members of the Rob Corps members of the
Rob Corps for 24 years I have been
reading X-Men Comics the first comic I
ever really bought on my own for 24
years on reading the X-Men comic I'm
reading everything that's happened with
the X-Men over the course of the last 24
years and then retroactively going back
and reading most of Chris claremont's
run not all of it but most of it I could
say without arrogance I am one of the
most knowledgeable X-Men people out
there and this story is amazing
all of you guys have to go and buy this
story this story is is awesome it is oh
my God I can't wait to see how this
whole thing ends okay so the good thing
about House of X is is that you really
don't need to have read the X-Men before
to understand it right because like
along the way Jonathan Hickman explains
pretty much everything you need to know
but for those of you guys who are
confused you have me so uh so so what
this does this picks up with a handful
of different locations right so you
basically end up having like krakowa you
end up having Westchester then you have
the blue area of the Moon and then you
have like Mars and you've got Washington
DC and and it goes through through like
a chronological order right so like four
months ago running all the way up until
till the modern day and it even goes as
far as to pick up in the Savage land and
what's Happening Here is like all these
these flowers are essentially being
planted and initially it kind of threw
me off I was like why in the world are
the X-Men going around the world you
know planting flowers are they like part
of Greenpeace now or are they like
environmental description you know but
it's kind of cool because what you end
up learning is that there is there's
this kind of organization called Orchid
more or less but there's a few
Representatives who show up here to one
of these sites uh that have basically
been summoned here by the X-Men and
there's a handful of them there for the
most part these are essentially new guys
they're not really old school instead
once they arrive in this location
they're greeted by Sophie and Esme of
the Stepford cacus now for those of you
guys who don't know who this stuff for
Cuckoos are they are part of the weapons
plus project we've talked about that
before right the idea that Captain
America was weapon one all that stuff
was covered under Grant Morrison's new
X-Men run but Grant Morrison basically
established that like weapons plus began
with project rebirth Weapon 1 Captain
America he was originally designed to
kill mutants but the whole system didn't
really work because Abraham Erskine was
killed and so on and so forth so he just
went for it as a super soldier and then
was frozen in ice and then from there
you got weapons two through through nine
and then you got weapon 10 or Weapon X
which is Wolverine and then you got a
handful of projects after that Phantom X
Deadpool different things along those
lines this step for Cuckoos were an
attempt to clone Emma Frost and to
basically create someone like her that
could be used for their own ends now
ultimately it didn't really work but the
stuff for cocoos are different from Emma
in the sense that where Emma Frost in
and of herself is a super high level
telepath the step for Goku's
individually are very powerful but they
had the ability to kind of share a hive
mind like all of their minds can
effectively work in unison and then they
turn into a situation where they're
greater than the sum of their parts so
it's it's cool like they're they're a
pretty interesting organization or a
pretty interesting group but then
suddenly all these guys are met with the
arrival of Magneto now Magneto's arrival
here is no small thing and the reason
why is because remember for the most
part when it when it comes to the this
run on the X-Men while you don't have to
have read anything before it it's not as
though the X-Men are appearing for the
very first time in Marvel Comics right I
mean they've been around for a long time
there's a lot of history there right
that's one of the reasons why it's so
cool is because there's a lot of
callbacks here but Magneto has always
kind of been known as a mutant extremist
and so when he shows up here it's kind
of like okay so like are things gonna go
to pot now what Hickman does here this
is cool is he kind of interjects and
throws in these flowers of krakowa
basically tells us what they are now
this is where things start to get really
really interesting and we'll talk about
cocoa here in a second because this is
not new so the way this works is that
the flowers of cocoa produce three
different types of flowers for both
mutants and humans right so for humans
you've basically got a drug it's kind of
a synthesized pill that can enhance
human life or extend human life by five
years then you've got one that can
that's a synthesized pill yet again or
at least could be synthesized into a
pill and then it's basically a super
drug for humans right like like a super
antibiotic and then the last one
actually eliminates all diseases Inside
the Mind of humans now for mutants these
flowers function with a totally
different purpose one of them produces
is gateways right basically you can
plant a flower and then it'll grow and
it'll turn into a portal essentially the
second one will actually grow into a
habitat which is totally self-sustaining
and then the third one will grow into a
habitat that krakowa doesn't know about
now why does that matter okay so this is
partially explained by Gene but I think
it also kind of involves a little bit
more in-depth explanation here as to
what's going on with Jean Gray in this
scene she's basically bringing a young
kid a pass through a portal at what used
to be the Westchester Institute the
Xavier school for gifted youngsters and
they enter into like this whole new
section with Cipher talking directly to
kakoa so the way this works is that
krakowa used to be a living Island and
recently Marvel changed that to
basically say that gracoa was an actual
person you can blow all that off you
don't really need to worry about all
that but the way this played out is
krakowa was a living Island and the way
this happened was that the original
X-Men by Stanley and Jack Kirby wasn't
very very popular right I mean it didn't
do exceedingly well so it was canceled
some 60 issues into his run and there
was reprints for the next 30 or so
issues and so by the time he got around
to the Run of Chris Claremont the
Prelude to that was called giant size
X-Men number one and what giant size
X-Men number one did is it basically
Blended the two groups and it said that
what had happened was the original X-Men
group of of Jean Gray and and cyclops
and Iceman and Beast and Angel they had
all been captured on the living island
of krakowa and the result was that
Xavier had to form a new X-Men team now
there is a more recent story that
introduces Gabriel Summers uh also known
as Vulcan the character of Darwin things
like that called deadly Genesis which
tells us there was actually a secret
X-Men team that Xavier formed that were
all thought to have perished in battle
and that nobody really knew about it he
kept it really hidden but with regards
to this discussion the island is a
living functioning ion that's actually a
mutant right so I mean it's kind of
tying into the way that was done by
Marvel but eventually like the new X-Men
team of like Colossus and and storm and
Wolverine and Banshee and their Sunfire
they were all brought in and basically
rescued the original X-Men team and then
they all kind of merged into a singular
group Sunfire I think left he he took
off he's like this is kind of stupid but
everybody else stayed around and that
formed the the Chris Claremont X-Men
team going forward now Cipher is a
character he's basically a guy who could
understand any language so he's
basically the only one that can
communicate with krakowa with the island
itself but more so than that it's kind
of a cool moment because we also get
this depiction of what Charles Xavier
looks like right that like he wears this
helmet with his ex on it he looks a lot
like the maker from uh from from
Hickman's ultimate Fantastic Four run in
the Ultimate Universe so it's cool like
it's it's interesting but what this also
does from here is it basically brings in
an organization called uh called orcas
but then also brings back Karima I think
it's Karima I'm pretty sure that's how
you pronounce her name but basically
orcas is kind of like this this
clandestine organization that's composed
of a bunch of different groups what
orcas did is it essentially went around
to advance idea mechanics the the
technology arm of Hydra they went to to
essentially what was left of Shield
because remember Shield is just kind of
in shambles at the moment oh they went
and they got grabbed strike they grabbed
sword they grabbed Alpha flight they
grabbed Hammer armor as well as members
of Hydra they brought them all together
under a singular team and the entire
basis behind orcas is to analyze the
mutant threat and to maintain it I guess
maintain itself was kind of a watchdog
and essentially like observe mutant
influence right like Financial influence
their influence in governments their
influence and how they work around the
world their spying program they're
designed to monitor the mutant threat
now for Karima herself it's it's
interesting the way that Hickman does
this right because originally Karima was
what was known as an Omega Prime signal
now there is a distinction here what you
have in Marvel is you had what were
called Prime Sentinels then you had
Omega Prime Sentinels Prime Sentinels
were basically biological Sentinels
right so they were like if a human was
grafted with cybernetic implants using
nanotechnology and then kind of sent
forward now the way this played out
originally again like in in uh in the
events of operation Zero Tolerance was
that it was a way for Bastion to kind of
infiltrate the world right like having
these individuals who were bonded with
cybernetic technology and then function
as sleeper agents right so they would be
they would be essentially like
masquerading as humans and nobody would
know not even they would know right like
they would be quote unquote activated
and then they would just emerge and they
would start carrying out the bidding of
of Bastion now of course those guys were
defeated the idea behind the Omega Prime
Sentinel behind uh behind Karima
chapandar was that she was designed to
be a character designed to be a kind of
Sentinel that could basically modify
herself and adapt to the various ability
of the people she faced off against
right like that's what made her so
dangerous now over the years she really
just kind of became more of a background
character and she never really evolved
or grew a whole lot I mean she did she
was involved in some of the things that
came out but it was never like she never
really see achieved like the same level
of significance I think as she did
originally during her introduction back
in 2000 and so because of this with what
Hickman's doing here you can either kind
of choose to ignore everything that took
place after Bastion or you can go ahead
and just kind of throw it in there it
really doesn't matter now the other
thing to bear in mind here too is that
when it comes to Orcas and when it comes
to everything that's going on the reason
why the orcas protocols were enacted was
in response to something called the
Cro-Magnon problem and the Cro-Magnon
problem was a article more or less there
was written by somebody named Dr Alia
Greger and what this did is it released
what Hickman does here is he actually
establishes this and then rolls it over
and really brings it out of the events
of ES4 Extinction now ES4 Extinction was
the first story arc done by Grant
Morrison back in 2000 2001 and the way
this played out is you had a villain
named Cassandra Nova who was essentially
like the well initially like the twin of
Xavier but then it turned out she was
like a alien called the mummer die or
something like that it was weird but the
overall gist of this is that she had
essentially gone into the world and then
activated what were called The Wild
Sentinels and these were Sentinels who
were just that were kind of created and
engineered outside of the purview of the
federal government and then they were
sent to genocia and jenosha ended up
wiping out 16 million mutants right like
that's one of the big things right like
the deaths of 16 million on the island
of genocia and so what this does and
it's a genius idea by Hickman what he
does is he comes back and he basically
says Okay so the way that that played
out because of the the rate at which
mutants were growing essentially mutants
would have like overpopulated like there
would have been more mutants on Earth
than humans within 10 years of the ES4
Extinction event had it not happened and
so what it did is it basically bought
Humanity 20 years now one thing Hickman
does not bring up here that I find is
interesting are the events of House of M
right where like Scarlet Witch came back
and wiped out there took away the powers
of 98 of the mutant population now the
reason why I think he really did that is
because those were simply removing their
powers and then eventually a lot of
those Powers began to come back with e
is for extinction those mutants were
dead and gone right like the population
was significantly reduced by a pretty
huge margin and I would say given the
number of mutants who lost their powers
versus the numbers of number of mutants
who died during ease 4 extension that
the ES4 Extinction event had a much
bigger impact because more mutants were
affected under that entire thing right
like they were all living on genocia and
mutant Island that was designed to be a
refuge and so with that being the case
essentially like human Humanity like the
reason why orcas exists is because
Humanity's in panic mode Humanity has 20
years until mutants overtake them on the
the population level right so there's
more mutants than there are humans and
that makes them panicky because of the
fact that if mutants under that
circumstance decided to rise up and kill
all the humans but what are the humans
gonna do about it so again like it
creates kind of a finicky situation now
this leads into mystique and Sabertooth
and Toad who are basically launching an
attack seemingly based on the the
contested information or the contested
database of damage control now the way
this works again with damage control is
they were initially a contract group
they were a company that existed out
there that would clean up towns and
cities and essentially clean up after
the catastrophes and involve like
superhero superhero battles and things
like that so damage control has been
pretty seedy over the years but more
recently what Hickman establishes is
that damage control has actually served
as a means by which information is
cataloged regarding the various
superheroes around the world and after
the events of Secret Wars when Reed
Richards was missing for a number of
years and after the events of Civil War
II until when Tony Stark was believed to
have been dead all the information they
had at their disposal was taken by
damage control and is now contested as
to who it actually belongs to but until
that contestation comes to an end and
until a definitive person is established
as being the individual that information
does belong to damage control holds on
to it now from here switching back over
to Magneto this is when Humanity begins
to make their intentions known this is
when they begin to kind of reveal the
fact that there is some Fear Factor
going on here that when these
representatives are talking to Magneto
and they're talking about the ability to
create portals and for the X-Men to move
groups from one part of the world to the
other that is kind of terrifying because
what it can mean is that mutants could
conceivably start moving their forces
from one side of the planet to the next
and move it around a different location
without anybody being able to track
their movements right like they enter a
portal and nobody knows where they're
going to come out now of course there
has to be a twin on the other side right
like there has to be a Gateway that you
can come out of if there's a Gateway you
can go into it's only they suddenly
appear the entire stance of Magneto is
that's the problem with you guys the
problem with you guys is you assume
everything we're doing is for the
purpose of making War but Xavier made a
proposal to you guys and that's that's
kind of the big thing that happened here
before the story picked up is that
Xavier made a proposal to humanity and
what he said was we want an era of Peace
like we're tired of being hunted we're
tired of being chased we've won an era
of Peace essentially like we are the
rifle inheritors to the world we are
those individuals who are the next stage
of human evolution and historically
speaking the more evolved race conquers
the less evolved race it's the way
things work but we don't want a war you
know in this situation that we're in
humanity on its in its base form is
evolved enough that they could wage war
against mutants and it would have mass
casualties and Xavier of course being a
leader of the X-Men wanting to be the
guy who maintains the mutant population
maintains that sort of Peace has
essentially adopted like the ideology of
Magneto and so far as Avalon now Avalon
or asteroid M or whatever you want to
call it Providence any number of things
it's been called different things over
the years this was a concept that was
created by Magneto as a way for mutants
to actually leave Earth and then have a
refuge off of the Earth itself Xavier
hated the idea right I mean that's what
led into the events of uh fatal
attractions when Magneto ripped the
adamantium out of Wolverine's body but
um Xavier hated the idea because in his
mind it was abandoning the notion of
like having peace between humans and
mutants and so of course that led kind
of deep in the rift between himself and
Magneto and led to the events of fatal
attractions which led into Onslaught and
all that kind of stuff but the overall
idea here is that what Xavier is
basically doing is saying we can all
cohabitate on Earth it'll be one of
these things where you stay away and we
stay away now it's kind of a cool moment
here because when all this happens when
you end up having like the forces of
Mystique and the forces of of Sabretooth
and Toad all of them making for the
Gateway trying to get out as fast as
they can Sabertooth kind of stays behind
faces off against Ben Grimm the thing
which is kind of interesting to see
because I don't know even at his best if
if Sabertooth even back in the 80s when
he was just like crazy and hardcore I
don't know if he would have been able to
take on Ben Graham but here's the thing
I really hope Hickman brings back that
version of sabertooth right like the
1980s Chris Claremont Sabertooth who was
just insane right just like this mad
Beast that would just wipe out ever
because here's the thing if you took
like 1980 saber tooth and you threw him
into stories today while he'd Massacre
people it'd be like if kids these days
went to like an Xbox Live Lobby from
like 10 years ago where like they'd
never make it like it's just it's one of
those one of those interesting kind of
scenarios and so on his way to try to
get out he's suddenly captured by Susan
storm and they were met by the arrival
of Reed as as well as Ben Grimm and
Johnny Storm and so this is when things
come into play where Cyclops shows up
and says hey look we need Cyclops or we
need we need saber tooth back and Reed
initially like rejects his offer no like
he broke into a facility that has
information that I've been trying to get
back he's broken any number of laws and
it's kind of a cool thing right because
what it does is it establishes this
precedent that even from a superhero to
Superhero level right like the Fantastic
Four and the X-Men having fought against
each other having served together like
all these kind of creating these
scenarios where the X-Men can't just
sort of say hey we are now a Sovereign
Nation right like we are now now a
Sovereign Place living out on the island
of krakowa we do our own thing and then
suddenly show up and say like any Mutant
is captured by humanity is immediately
taken by us it doesn't work that way
that when International laws are broken
this suddenly things get a lot more
complicated and so it's not as clear-cut
seemingly as the extreme would like it
to be that instead it's one of these
things of you guys being a Sovereign
Nation now you have to deal with
intertangling alliances now you have to
deal with things like if an American
citizen went to another country and
violated their laws well then what
happens you know how does all that work
so again it becomes a lot more
complicated and a lot more difficult to
focus on now this is probably one of the
biggest changes that that Jonathan
Hickman makes not really a change so
much as a consolidation as he starts to
focus on the nature of Omega Level
mutants now this is a cool thing because
in Marvel Comics Omega classification
was something that was kind of teased by
Chris Claremont over the years but you
never really saw it all that often right
it would just be like it was more of
like a way to kind of name a person or
or say like this person's powerful as
opposed to actually organizing and
structuring powers and so the way this
works is is on a baseline level you have
like gamma-based mutants right like
gamma level mutants super weak
essentially after that you have beta
which are a little more powerful then
you have Alpha which is like most of the
mutant population resides there and then
you have omega now Omega is is as
Hickman describes it here and it wasn't
really vague so much I mean it kind of
was back in the day it was just no no
undefinable upper limit and that was
that was it there's a limit to their
powers they cannot truly be defined
right like what's the limit of reality
warping can you only warp so much of the
universe or can you only can you warp
all of the universe right like on that
scale of power it doesn't matter it's
just an extreme level of power and so
because of that what Hickman does here
is he basically breaks it down and
consolidates it and says Okay so the way
this works when it comes to Omega Level
mutants is you effectively have those
where we just don't know what the limits
of their power are and he literally
Compares Magneto and he Compares Forge
and he says forge's power could be
surpassed right like Ford is a character
whose mutant ability grants him the
ability to know how things work right so
he's basically like a mutant version of
Tony Stark now if he lost his mutant
power he would be wouldn't be capable he
wouldn't be able to do anything but Tony
Stark is more capable than Forge
therefore Forge is not not Omega Level
because his power can be surpassed
whereas Magneto we don't know the limits
of his power all we know is he's just
like this guy that can manipulate the
entire electromagnetic spectrum but how
deep does that go is he manipulating the
electromagnetic spectrum because he's
manipulating all forms of energy is he
doing it because he's manipulating
things on the atomic level if it has a
form it has atoms and so if the form can
be manipulated presumably the atomic
structure can be manipulated these are
the questions that we don't have answers
to and that's what Hickman is
essentially saying here is we don't know
the limits of Magneto's power all we
know is that they seem to have no upper
limit or if it does we haven't
discovered it yet and so because we have
not discovered it yet Magneto is
considered Omega Level it's a pretty
cool idea it's a pretty cool concept and
what he says is usually like when
mutants have multiple powers only one of
those Powers is ever really going to be
an Omega Level classification right so
Jean Grace got telepathy and she's got
telekinesis but she's only in Omega
Level telepath she's not in Omega Level
telekinetic right like she can't move a
world with her mind and so it's it's a
it's a cool moment here because then
what you have following that is this
this amazing discussion that goes on
between Magneto and the guys that he
brought here these humans that he
brought here in order to show them
everything that's happening and you end
up having one of the stepper Cuckoos
that basically says hey look like all
these people are like skeptical of us
and she goes through and and starts
reading their minds and revealing what
it is that they're about right like this
this guy ma Ming do I think is how you
pronounce his name uh he's basically
ahead of like the state Science office
right like you got Peter Cole who I'm
sorry Jean-Pierre Cole uh who's here
because he doesn't really want to be uh
you have all these people who are
basically in this position because
they're kind of being forced to but one
of the big things that that really like
humanity is looking at even from just a
financial Financial aspect is they say
okay so basically this island of krakowa
is creating these these flowers that can
be synthesized into pills that like
extend longevity Krakow is making pills
that like cure people of mental mental
illness cocoa is making these pills that
basically kind of seem to eliminate the
need for like pharmaceutical Industries
right so like the entire pharmaceutical
sector of the United States of humanity
would come crashing down because why
would you buy a drug that may or may not
help you with you know schizophrenia or
something like that if all you have to
do is pop this miracle pill and then
suddenly you're cured it would kill the
entire pharmaceutical industry but it
also begins you know really kind of
drives him to ask the question of is
what if these mutants start taking these
pills will it work on them do we need to
worry about another Stamford Connecticut
where they basically exposed to a mutant
growth hormone that amplifies their
powers and then they're suddenly like
giant wrecking machines I mean are these
the things that we need to worry about
you know and it's kind of cool because
as a stuffer Crews go through it's like
well this guy's got a gun Magneto takes
the gun away from him and he says you
know like when one of them say it's just
for my protection but his response is
that's how it always starts right it
starts with one group being afraid of
another and then and trying to impose
their will on the other so they can
essentially eliminate their own fear
right it always works out that way it's
you are doing a thing that's different
from what I'm used to it scares me
therefore I'm going to take my belief
I'm going to impose it on you and if you
resist then we just need to remove you
right like it's my way or the highway
it's really kind of how that whole thing
starts and so it's cool because Magneto
basically starts talking to them and
says look the reason why I brought you
here to Jerusalem you're not going to
krakowa you're not going there because
it's our Island it's our Safe Haven no
humans man is not allowed there but you
can basically take this message and take
it back to your leaders that the world
has changed you guys love your symbolism
right I mean it's one of the coolest
things man you know says you guys love
your symbolism almost as much as you
love your religion so please like what
I'm telling you here is to go back and
to tell all your Masters tell your
bosses tell all the humans that you come
across that you guys have new Gods now
we are the ones running the show it's
the coolest thing right it's the coolest
thing ever
okay so we're officially getting into
powers of X really it's like powers of
10 I think is what it is one of them is
I think is House of X and then powers of
ten I think is how this comes out anyway
powers of X basically is what it's
called or at least that's what I'm
calling it
and this this is now let me tell you
something dude this story is really
really good at least this first issue is
amazing all right so in traditional
Hickman fashion what we get is basically
this kind of time chronology that we're
gonna follow over the course of this
series right if you know how to read
Hickman's stories like if you know how
to interpret what he does in the
beginning then you know how to basically
navigate the Waters of the story going
forward right so we get basically year
one which is the current year right now
or the the I guess really in the past
right like you know the idea of when the
X-Men were first founded essentially
which is the dream of Charles Xavier
following that you go into year 10 which
could basically conceive or at least
soon to be the present day which is the
world as it exists now uh and then year
100 which is 100 years from now the war
that breaks out and we'll talk about
that here in a second and then following
that is when mutants basically Ascend to
their higher state of evolution so it's
really really cool it's it's really
really badass but what this does is it
initially picks up with Charles Xavier
just kind of Meandering around and just
sort of looking at things and then
ultimately he's met by what appears to
be more a McTaggart now more mctaggard
in Marvel Comics for those of you guys
who are new and I feel like this is
really kind of important thing to
explain here for those of you guys who
are new to the X-Men more McTaggart is
not new she's been around for a long
long time but the basis behind her is
that if Charles Xavier is the instructor
for mutants which is to say the one who
teaches them how to use their powers
then Maura mctaggard is a mutant
geneticist who understands how their
powers work now the two of them often
work hand in hand and the way this
played out is that she had her own group
for example like the New Mutants a lot
of you guys have probably heard of that
if only because the movie's supposed to
be coming out which I'm probably not
going to go see the idea behind that is
it was a handful of mutants that had
been discovered by by Maura mchaggart
that she was keeping on your Island to
understand their powers how they work
how they function to see if they're kind
of like any significant danger now with
the two of them working hand in hand
what would happen here is that if if
Charles Xavier discovered a mutant who
had really any powers he could be
classified as dangerous right like
anything that was unpredictable or could
cause all kinds of problems and he
didn't really know how they worked he
would take them to more mctaggard and
more McTaggart would analyze their
powers and then give Charles Xavier an
answer and then Charles Xavier would
cater his teaching process around the
nature sure of their powers right so
it's kind of cool in terms of how they
function but the discussion here is
Charles Xavier kind of hitting at the
idea to Maury McTaggart that like he
wants to create a better world now of
course he doesn't reveal to her here
that he has telepathy Charles Xavier
kept his powers guarded for a long long
time right it was one of the big things
about his character the first time that
anybody really learned about his
abilities outside of his brother Kane
Marco who eventually became the
Juggernaut was Magneto when the two of
them got into a bar fight with a whole
bunch of different guys and they both
used their powers and they basically
kind of revealed themselves to the other
in terms of what they could do what
their abilities were and then that kind
of led to a rift later on when they had
two different ideologies on how to
navigate the waters between mutant and
human relations but the idea behind this
is It's really you know more MCT Haggard
saying Hey I want to go see a fortune
teller and this fortune teller came to
me with a vision of source she came to
me with the magician the Tower and the
Devil Himself and it's kind of cool to
see these these things play out because
we'll actually find out who these
characters are so I'm not going to spoil
anything by now what she tells Charles
Xavier here where he says well you know
I've I had this dream of a better world
and I want to create a better place and
things like that and what more mchaga
says is it's not really a dream if it's
real and so what this does is really
seem to hit at the idea that the bases
behind why Charles Xavier pursue pursued
his dream of a peaceful coexistence is
because of the fact that like more make
tagger sort of inspired him to do that
but then this is when we start to learn
that not everything is what it appears
to be now again we're ballparking here
when it comes to more we're not
explicitly told as her we're just kind
of left to assume that it is but then
she addresses him directly as Charles
and the fact that he doesn't know who
she is the fact that he's never met her
really kind of begs the question how
does she know who he is and she says
when we go back quite a ways read my
mind and see that's always kind of like
okay so like it's it's it's it's it's a
mystery like it's mysterious and that's
the nature of of Hickman riding right
like we probably won't get an answer to
that question until like powers of X
number four
it's it's crazy the way the whole thing
works out now at this point we basically
pick up with the modern day right the
X-Men year 10 what's currently going on
right now and this basically follows the
aftermath of House of X so if you guys
haven't read that story or haven't seen
that video then make sure you go check
it out I don't have the link down in the
description or you can go and grab the
comic or whatever the case is for you uh
but basically this follows the immediate
aftermath of that right you know
Mystique basically showing back up to
Cocoa the the current residence the
location that the X-Men reside in or at
least that a large large majority of the
mutants reside in that only the mutants
can access she comes back of course with
this with this hard drive of sorts hands
it over to Magneto and then we get our
first real display here of of Charles
Xavier now again it's not really Charles
Xavier putting like the the full
totality of his power he's just kind of
there and we really don't know the
intentions of Xavier all indications and
the whole tone that's being put off here
is he seems like he's kind of a dick now
like he's kind of a bad guy and and
maybe maybe he's not we're not really
sure but when it comes to Xavier it's
always been trying to achieve a peaceful
coexistence between humans and mutants
but when you have phrases being thrown
out there where Xavier says no your
Humanity while you slept the world
changed it's just kind of like okay so
it seems like Xavier is becoming a
little more militaristic or a little
more extreme in terms of pursuing his
own goals and that's kind of the crazy
thing here because as this happens you
end up having this this you know sort of
discussion between himself and Mystique
you know where she says we have more
demands because of what it is has taken
place here so obviously Mystique isn't
really doing this for the betterment of
mutant Khan and Xavier says well that's
fine you know because we we also have
demands too like we have things that we
want to achieve as well uh and in this
world if you're going to live here in
kakoa and you're going to be a part of
it then everybody here owes something
everybody here is going to have to pay a
price and that's kind of the crazy thing
because we don't find out what that is
instead we jump to what I think is
actually the coolest part of the story
The Man machine war and this is awesome
so this place takes place 100 years in
the future right I mean most of you guys
can tell I'm excited about this this
place takes place 100 years into the
future and basically a war is broken out
between humanity and mutants but the
difference here is that the the humanity
has Allied itself with machines now what
this appears to be is kind of like it's
almost kind of like the Days of Future
Past film kind of being rolled into the
comic book form not in the exact way
right it's a lot more extreme here and
really the indication as it was put off
by Days of Future Past in the movie was
that humans were working with the
Sentinels but really more because it was
like if you don't we're going to
eradicate you right so it was more of an
undesirable alliance between these two
groups and this it really looks like
they're actually working in a peaceful
coexistence with each other and of
course what they're doing you know what
it really seems to have happened here is
that that these mutants have basically
gotten their hands on something in
particular now what I also wanted to
take note of is one of these characters
here that has a black brain and we'll
kind of follow up with that here in a
second and find out what's going on but
of course she's immediately captured by
a combination of uh really the forces of
like these massive Sentinels and also
with these super Advanced artificial
artificial intelligence robots now what
you also have here is a young girl who
looks like she's uh like the daughter of
like Nightcrawler and magic and then
somebody who also kind of looks like a
spin-off version of Nightcrawler right
so like these two people look like
they're descended from Nightcrawler
himself and it's kind of weird in terms
of how their physical depiction comes
out here but the way this is being done
is that this this particular mutant with
a black brain is essentially being taken
by Humanity right I mean like you know
her chance of Escape is virtually
non-existent uh but the idea is that
with this young boy here this this
red-skinned mutant guy he doesn't really
want to fight he follows very much in
line with Nightcrawler where he's like
I'm really more of a of a peaceful guy
but this kid is really more like a
priest he really follows a strong
religion and truly believes in the act
of pacifism and so where you end up
having you know this this young girl
who's addressed as being Rasputin which
we'll talk about that here in a second
but when she's addresses Rasputin and
she basically jumps in destroys one of
the machines and then tries to rescue
this woman with a black brain ultimately
it doesn't work out instead this young
girl is taken away by the Sentinels and
and Rasputin is associated as kind of
left to survive as best she can and
that's when we start to get into what's
going on here and so what we end up
finding out is that somewhere between
the present day and 100 years in the
future that the villain Mr Sinister
became an ally or at least seemed to
become an ally of the mutant population
now the reason why this is important is
because for those of you guys who don't
know Mr Sinister is a guy named
Nathaniel Essex right at one point in
time he was a human but he was obsessed
with the idea that the human genealogy
was predicated on change that's
somewhere along the line the genes of
humans were modified and they were he
was correct about that but he didn't
really have the evidence to prove it he
didn't really know exactly how it had
happened of course we know it was due to
the celestials but the result is that he
believed that somewhere along the line
that whatever these genes were would
begin to manifest and people would begin
to develop powers and he simply called
them mutants now eventually the villain
apocalypse approached Nathaniel Essex
after learning about his his discussions
and his his topics and research and so
on and Nathaniel Essex basically
revealed to apocalypse that he was a
mutant which was the first time that
apocalypse realized what he was and so
following that apocalypse basically used
this technology to turn Nathaniel Essex
into Mr Sinister and give him an
insanely long life if not full-on
immortality and so ever since then
Nathaniel Essex has always been toying
with the idea of messing with humor with
with mutant genes and seeing if he could
just create more powerful characters
right I mean mutants have always just
kind of been an experiment for him now
because of the story The Adventures of
Cyclops and Phoenix uh we ended up
finding out the reason why it is a
Sinister was so obsessed with creating a
child based on the genes of Cyclops and
and Jean Gray and we'll find we'll talk
about more you know talk about that more
in like a different video or something
like that but at the moment what seems
to have happened here is sometime
between this 100 Year window the present
day and 100 years from now that Sinister
began the purpose when this war broke
out he began basically genetically
modifying mutants and so what he would
do is he would take a mutant or or he
would like build a mutant from scratch
and he would give him the genes of like
multiple characters and so for this
character Rasputin she basically has the
telepathy of Quentin choir who's an
Omega Level telepath she's got the
powers of Mikhail Rasputin who's the
brother of Colossus and he can basically
manipulate energy the powers of Kitty
Pride to face through objects she's got
the healing factor of Laura Kinney she's
literally like a One-Stop shop now the
way this worked is that you basically
had like Generations one two three and
four and as these Generations went on
the likelihood of survival for these
Generations began to drop off in the
sense that like there was more of a
chance of Destruction here now what the
mutants began to realize over time is
that none of this was really being done
by Sinister for the purpose of helping
Newton Khan it was being done by
Sinister for his own goals his own
nefarious purposes and So eventually
what seems to have happened here is
Sinister was working for the purpose of
of developing kind of like this perfect
mutant more or less and when that
happened he would hand it over to
humanity and for whatever that reason
happened to be right most likely because
Humanity I had promised him the ability
to experiment on mutants as much as he
wanted to when they were captured and so
on and so forth what ended up happening
is that when Sinister defected to The
Human Side he was publicly executed we
don't really know the the explicit
details of this you know we just kind of
know the project side of what Sinister
is doing or at least he was doing and
then most likely we'll find an answer
that later on down the line but that
kind of begs the question if humans and
mutants are working together then who's
running the show here and that's when we
get an answer to the question that the
show is being ran by two people the
first is an evolved human who basically
is going by the name Omega and the
second is Nimrod and that's the coolest
thing because Nimrod is a character that
we have not seen for a long long time
those of you guys who don't know Nimrod
hails from Days of Future Past right so
the idea was that Sentinels are taken
over North America during Days of Future
Past and they basically you know they
they captured all mutants they could
find everywhere and even humans were
thrown into internment camps but what
the Sentinels were working on was a
perfect version of themselves a perfect
a perfect Sentinel but what seems to
have happened here is that Nimrod has
been created yet again the difference is
that this version of nimrod does not
appear to be like the like the one that
we're normally used to right like the
traditional version of nimrod is pretty
screwed up like he's pretty dark and
pretty sadistic we can assume this is
the same version and just kind of
evolved or it's a new version we don't
really have any answers to that question
yet you know what it's kind of left to
sort of make our own guess and just kind
of go from there but with these humans
showing up with this Blackberry mutant
who's now known as cylabel what we learn
is that they've gone through all kinds
of like torturous systems in order to
get the information out of her in terms
of what Rasputin and these other mutants
were after and where she refused to
reveal this information what Nimrod
basically says is like what they're
gonna do is they're going to take her
and they're going to give her what's
called a bath and the reason why they
call it that is because they're going to
essentially put her in a tank where
she's going to be broken down not really
broken down in terms of physical form
but we're nanites are essentially going
to enter and take over her body and all
the information that she has is going to
essentially become a part of the Nimrod
Mainframe and that is to say like the
machine Mainframe and all that
information will be readily available
and it's kind of a crazy scenario
because you know cylabel initially kind
of tries to put off this air like I'm
not afraid I'm not worried about this
and if you think threatening me is
really gonna cause problems for me you
have no idea what I'm really about but
ultimately none of it matters because
when she gets dunked into this tank the
nanites do their work and she's a shell
of her former self just like that she's
essentially gone it's a death that she
can't really escape from right I mean
she's kind of stuck there for for
essentially all time and that's kind of
the crazy thing is because all the
information she has is going to be
extracted all the information she has is
going to be taken away but her physical
form is not going to be destroyed she's
just going to kind of be left there now
the indication here is that in terms of
her Consciousness and her sentience it's
still there she's just kind of in a
catatonic state but also kind of
seemingly aware of what's going on I
know it seems like a contradiction but
that seems to be the way these systems
work right I mean she's just kind of
taken over and that's the end of her but
one of the things that needs to be
pointed out here is that cylabel was
actually what's called a Hound now
Jonathan Hickman is not making this up
this is actually something that existed
from the events of Days of Future Past
and even to a degree the Age of
Apocalypse so the way this worked when
you come out of Days of Future Past and
you kind of look at that scenario one of
the questions a lot of people had is
well why did mutants just go underground
how is it the Sentinels were finding
them and the Sentinels were doing that
by using hounds they were using mutants
to hunt other mutants and that's the way
this played out here it was the creation
of hounds designed to track down other
mutants now this seems to be an
indication of like what Sinister was
doing when he defected from him from
mutant kind and then went over to
humanity was presumably creating hounds
there's no reason to believe that's
entirely the case but that kind of seems
to be the case the issue with this is
that by the time you know with the the
first wave right like the first the
first generation of hounds that were
created they were designed for the
purpose to elicit sympathy from from
mutant kind the issue with this is that
they weren't really effective Hunters
because they were designed to be more
more kind and more bass in terms of
their function right so following this
came the second generation of hounds and
the second generation of hounds were
designed to basically insert themselves
into mutant encampments and then
basically like wipe them all out the
issue with this is as Jonathan Hickman
tells us because they were based on
being on the design of being duplicitous
right of the design of basically
betrayal ultimately they betrayed humans
and machines and joined the mutant
population right so it's very similar to
the concept of like Terminator the the
idea that they were basically taking
like human skin and sweat and hair and
blood and all that kind of stuff and
grafting it over a robot skeleton and
then sending them into infiltrate that
really kind of sees me what's going on
here with those particular folks and so
again what we do is we pick up with
Rasputin and uh this young guy entail
and basically show up with like what's
left of the mutant population and what
you have here is you have what looks
like Groot Wolverine and then you have I
think it's Zorn or Xeon I'm always
confused on which one it is and then
you've got somebody who looks like
Magneto now this is something I want to
draw your attention to especially when
it comes to Magneto there's no
indication that it's actually him
especially if we're dealing with what's
basically a hundred years into the
future Magneto is powerful but he's not
really powerful enough to like you know
slow his own aging and so because of the
fact that the costume is different the
indication seems to be that like it's a
wholly different form of his character I
like it's somebody else who's taken over
the role perhaps like another like
another son that he had because we know
Polaris has the ability to manipulate
magnetism but again this is obviously
not a woman and so it's interesting here
because what we end up learning is that
100 Years of the future after this war
broke out Mutant kind took off to two
different locations one of the locations
went out to What's called the Shia
Empire now the Shia Empire is basically
a massive Empire that exists out there
it's an amalgamation of different races
all swearing allegiancy to the Magister
or magistricts but they've also had a
lot of dealings with the mutant
population specifically as well as
earthlings and so the notion here is
that because of the relationship between
Charles Xavier and lelandra who is a who
was at one point the magistricts of the
queen or whatever you want to call it of
the Shia Empire that relationships have
always been maintained between mutants
and the Empire itself and so the result
was that they basically offered Safe
Haven and so of the ten thousand
surviving mutants who were left on Earth
8 000 live with the shiar the other 2000
actually end up living on the Shia
Homeworld now the 8000 are kind of like
on an orbiting satellite they kind of
exist out there but the other 2000 are
the most powerful of them and they're
basically those individuals who can be
picked and chosen by the shiar to join
the Imperial Guard the most powerful
fighting force in the entirety of the
universe so again there's there's kind
of a lot that goes on there for those
mutants who exist now now who basically
kind of reside within the population of
Earth there's only eight of them left
that's really there's only eight mutants
remaining on Earth during the events of
the man machine war and so what we end
up doing is picking up 1 000 years into
the future now in this future uh the
scenario is pretty interesting in terms
of how it's played out and the reason
why is because of course again you know
side of bell is still there but what
this also shows is that mutants
seemingly have won the man machine war
mutants essentially took over everything
or at the very least Humanity evolved in
the mutants and now everybody's mutant
around the world but the other thing
that's kind of given to us here is that
humans are still around right like
humans still exist Homo sapiens are
still there but they're really kept more
like zoo animals the entire world you
know as early as this section is now
called The Preserve right and they call
it that because like a nature preserve
or an animal preserve humans are kept
there they're monitored they're they're
you know really just sort of left to run
around in this small little area and
everything else has been taken over
Nimrod has kind of evolved now to where
he's a small little floating machine
more or less and this person whoever
this person is we're not really given a
name or anything like that seems to be a
mutant of sorts or the very least
evolved into something else we're not
entirely sure but it looks as though
mutants had basically achieved Ascension
the mutants have taken over everything
and they've achieved their highest level
of development more or less and so it's
kind of crazy because the war is now
over everything is done and mutants seem
to have won it all but again this is
only issue number one there's a lot of
questions that need to be answered here
there's a lot of questions that we got
to figure out and we don't know like we
don't know the answers to these
questions in reality we won't find out
until all 12 issues are done right until
House of X the six issue House of X
Series is done and the six issues power
of X Series has done we won't know until
all those are finished what the answers
to these things are
okay
for 25 years just about maybe give or
take a year six months seven months
something like that I've been reading
the X-Men and what Jonathan Hickman has
done in this second issue is make one of
the single biggest changes to the X-Men
Mythos that I think I've ever seen to be
honest that's one of the funny things
the X-Men Mythos doesn't really change
right I mean it never really changes all
that often like it's usually just kind
of the thing about like mutants are
persecuted humans want to get them and
then they gotta fight for their lives
and then on to the next volume that's
basically you know the Form and Function
their stories follow however what
Jonathan Hickman has done here is change
the Mythos of mutants who can
reincarnate which is to say they can
live forever and he does this by way of
a character named Moore McTaggart now
this is why this is so huge we've talked
about more mctaggard multiple times
right the idea of the shoe is just a
mutant geneticist she was a person who
would study mutants Powers if Charles
Xavier couldn't figure it out or if she
discovered them on her own and then she
and Charles Xavier would work together
to basically craft a kind of training
program for how those mutants would
function and and so on and so forth what
we end up learning here is that Maura
mctaggard has lived over and over and
over again she's actually lived a total
of 10 lives she's died and then been
reincarnated multiple times and it's
kind of the crazy thing because that's
her mutant power and that's why that's
so huge is because more McTaggart was
never a mutant she was just a normal
human with just the ability to
understand mutation and so on and so
forth she never had anything special
about her one of the first things that
we learned her at least one of the first
things that he tells us is that in her
younger years more McTaggart when she
was around 13 years old or so developed
fever now we're not really given an
exact time frame here uh we're kind of
left to believe that it was in like the
very early days of not really the early
days but like maybe like 100 years ago
or something along those lines but
basically she fell ill and then she was
supposed to have died now the result is
that she actually woke up and she was
white right as rain the next day and the
reason why is because presumably her
mutant power manifested now how that
affects reincarnation is not explicitly
given to us but what it does seem to
indicate is tried and true immortality
to a degree or at least a slowed aging
process the issue with that with that
theory with that idea is that she grew
old and she died thank you
it's kind of hard to argue immortality
when you pass peacefully in your sleep
at 74 years old
that circumstance because you know then
you're not Immortal but when that
happens she was born again the cool
thing about this is that when she was
when she was conceived when she was
reborn she basically ended up
remembering everything from her past
life now Hickman is a bit ambiguous
about this and one of the things he
doesn't answer is how is it that she's
reborn is she reborn to other parents or
is she reborn to the same parents and
just kind of living the same life over
and over again the idea seems to be that
she's just reborn but in a different
body every single time and that's one of
the things that he clarifies almost
immediately right so she's born and then
she comes out in a totally different
form than the way she looked when she
was younger now along the way in her
life uh more mctaggard eventually
encountered Charles Xavier not directly
she had simply just heard of him now the
cool thing about this is that Hickman
doesn't really go as far as to say more
Mick Hagrid is the reason why Charles
Xavier is the way he is she was really
more of like a silent Observer for a
long time when he first got his name out
there but until Hickman comes along and
changes things we can largely assume The
Life and Times of Charles Xavier are
still the same and so because of that
it's kind of funny because the way that
Hickman describes that when Professor X
got on TV and basically said hey look
here's what's going on out there and
there are mutants out there there are
people with powers and so on and so
forth this is tying in directly to
Charles Xavier's previous actions of
like admitting that he was a mutant on
National Television which was kind of a
big deal when it happened but the
overall tone she got from Xavier in his
early years is that he was arrogant that
he was a person who was overly confident
that he was kind of a dick and so it was
interesting because she didn't really
see you know looking at her own life and
how it functioned she didn't really see
Professor X's message of mutants being
the next stage of human evolution and
having powers is a blessing and you know
their gifts and so on and so forth she
never really saw it like that instead
she saw it more as a curse and so the
result was that mormick Hagrid
eventually developed a cure for the
mutant Gene she successfully developed a
way to eliminate mutations now what this
did is it led to the intervention of
Mystique and Destiny now a lot of you
guys who were new to the X-Men probably
don't know who Destiny is and that makes
sense she as far as I'm aware I mean I
think she's come back recently but there
was like a 20 maybe 30-year Gap in
Marvel Comics where she just wasn't
there Destiny was really and I don't
know if it was really hinted at so much
as an absolute thing but Destiny was the
love interest of Mystique and eventually
Destiny was killed off by Legion I think
it was and then that was the reason why
Mystique went to go kill Legion Legion
woke up out of a coma that kicks off
Legion Quest which goes into Age of
Apocalypse but the idea behind this was
that Destiny had the ability to see into
the future right she was a precog now it
wasn't really in so far as it's like
these are gonna be the winning winning
lottery numbers for tomorrow it was it
was one of these things where it's like
a conflict is coming later on down the
line she really seemed more like a
Cirrus or like a like a religious figure
you know in terms of how her powers
function and how they were depicted in
Marvel Comics as opposed to just kind of
being like make sure you go left when
you get to the fork in the road
otherwise you're gonna crash into a
truck and die you know it was
interesting the way that it worked but
for a long time mystique and destiny
were inseparable they were the one-two
punch of of the Brotherhood of evil
mutants in a lot of ways the X-Men's
villain group now there was kind of a
cool thing called Destiny's Diaries
right like after Destiny died there were
all these diaries that she had where she
had written out things that were going
to happen and it was like the hunt for
Destiny's Diaries it's a really really
cool set of events instant Marvel but
essentially what seems to have happened
here is that Destiny you know had a
vision of sorts of more McTaggart and
the future that her her Discovery would
lead to right the future would lead to
in terms of discovering a gene or I
guess a formula that could cure the
mutant Gene the result is that Destiny
says what you've done here is set in
motion a series of events that will lead
to a war that will lead to the
destruction of all things and that's why
the Brotherhood is here right because
what Moray tagger's done here she's
basically laid in motion a set of events
that's going to lead to the destruction
of all the mutants and so the
Brotherhood basically consisted of
Mystique and Destiny pyro and I don't
think there's anybody else I don't think
no Avalanche is there so this is back in
the 1980s presumably during the second
iteration of the Brotherhood of evil
mutants that what they've done what they
do is they basically say like we're
going to kill you like we're going to
destroy you and we're going to destroy
your cure and then you're gonna you know
you're gonna die and you're gonna be
reborn right because Destiny knows about
all this she's a pre-card but she's like
you're gonna die and you're gonna be
reborn and then take this knowledge into
the future and know that if you do this
again it'll lead to the destruction of
everything and so one of the things they
actually end up doing is burning her
alive right and like doing it slowly so
she just kind of has time to think about
what it means to truly die and so the
result is that when that happens when
she when she goes forward the formula is
still there she still creates it but
doesn't advertise it she doesn't go out
and tell anything instead what she does
is actually start growing closer to
Charles Xavier she starts focusing on on
what it is that he's looking for and so
this is really kind of changing the
history of it all right so like you know
chronologically you go through the
entire lifespan or the entire time that
Maura mctaggard has been in the X-Men
Comics originally all you got was Mio
Boy Meets Girl boy and girl fall in love
and then eventually they break up that
was basically what it was in terms of
Mora and Xavier what Hickman's doing
here is coming back and changing
everything and saying somewhere along
the line Maura McTaggart was born and
then she did some things and then she
died and then she was reborn and she did
some things and then she died then she
was reborn and then she met Charles
Xavier and that kind of picks up with
the modern era you know if you go if you
if you start with Chris Claremont and
you go through with more mctagon and all
the things that he did with her uh then
what you what you essentially are
looking at is the third life of Maura
McTaggart in Marvel Comics it's cool and
that's one of the things that Hickman
highlights he's says like she was there
by his side when the original X-Men were
formed when the giant size and and the
new launch of X-Men was formed when you
were talking about X you know Avengers
versus X-men and the death of Xavier
himself and then this future that
Destiny said would come to pass when the
humans would eradicate the entirety of
the mutant population this really seemed
to be more akin to like Days of Future
Past but still the deaths of all these
mutants at the hands of humans and then
eventually Sentinels and so really using
this life experience she has she tells
Xavier read my mind and see this teacher
that awaits us see what happens with
these things that I do and where she she
eventually achieves Xavier's Dream by
kind of having this bio Dome the various
mutants reside in that cuts itself off
in the rest of the world man attacks yet
again a war breaks out and then all the
mutants die and so the result is that
what she does is she looks at that and
she says okay so basically this is all
the fault of all of our Trask now again
a little bit of History here Bolivar
Trask was introduced in Marvel Comics as
part of Stanley and Jack Kirby's run on
the X-Men and the idea was that he was
the first one to create the Sentinels
right these giant robots that would
serve the purpose of whatever their
makers wanted following Bolivar Trask
and his defeat and presumed death of the
time although I believe he ended up
coming back what you got was Stephen
Lang and Stephen Lang those are the
signals the X-Men were fighting that was
the Prelude to the events of the Phoenix
and the dark Phoenix Saga and really
like a lot of the Sentinels that came
after now there were various people who
invented them after that but more makes
Haggard realize and that the entire
Sentinel program which is to say these
giant robots being controlled by man set
on the on the course of Kelly mutants
was all done at the hands of Bolivar
Trask she goes through and kills every
single member of the Trask family so
that hopefully none of this will come to
pass the result is that all of it does
anyway that at the end of the day
Humanity by for whatever Manner and
whatever means was hell-bent on creating
Sentinels and that leads to everything
that kind of took place and so what this
does is point to the idea that a war
between humans and mutants is inevitable
that it's going to happen and the reason
why isbe is is the same reason that
those conflicts have always broken out
and that's one of the things I love
about what Hickman's doing he's
introducing new things but kind of
saying all this has happened before and
all of it will happen again the entire
idea behind not really Stanley and Jack
Kirby's X-Men so much as Roy Thomas
Arnold Drake and then eventually Chris
Claremont going into like Jim Lee Scott
lodell uh Grant Morrison Chuck Austin
the whole idea behind like the writings
of these characters and the the nature
of the X-Men is the X-Men represent
Humanity in its current form being
removed and replaced by something better
and what it does is it instills fear in
humanity as it exists now right because
while they don't really rationalize it
in the sense of I will achieve a higher
state of being they rationalize it in
the sense of everything when we know
will change and it will go away right
like it's an inherent fear of change and
because of that fear and not really
being able to be able to understand the
mutant population they in turn lash out
against them now other things sort of
feed into that the notion that like
mutant Powers manifest and there's no
real way to know what kind of form
they're going to take right so like some
six-year-old kid sitting in his class
and it suddenly sucks the oxygen out of
the entire room because his powers kick
off because he's been bullied and he
goes into a heightened state of stress
or some girl is like 13 years old she
starts going through puberty and then
like lets off a massive explosion and
eradicates like half the United States
like there's no way to know if that's
what's going to happen that's one of the
other things that people are fearful
about is there's no way to be able to
check engage what kind of powers a
person is going to have it's random it's
arbitrary there's no real way to know
and so again there's a lot of fear
factors that go into uh into the the
human perception of mutants and why it
is that they're so angry and so because
of this what more Mick Haggard does and
she basically sides herself with Magneto
and she looks at this she says okay so
Charles Xavier has this idea of a
peaceful coexistence but that won't work
because Charles Xavier doesn't have the
balls to do what needs to be done in the
face of such hate and such such anger he
believes he can just talk people into
doing the right thing when they won't
Magneto's more heavy-handed hey if they
don't want to correct their act then
I'll correct it for them and that's what
she does she goes along with him and
basically says like here's everything
that's going to happen here's how this
world is going to unfold Magneto lashes
out loses it launches an attack by
firing firing like nuclear missiles at
the White House and the entirety of the
X-Men and the Avengers and the various
superheroes Fantastic Four The
Incredible Hulk and so on all team up
against Magneto and they all defeat him
so that that is yet again another
circumstance each one of these defeats
each one of these scenarios where she
sort of goes down a different path it's
her having died somewhere along the line
being reborn and trying to correct her
mistake and so following this then she
basically goes along and says okay fine
if the dream of Charles Xavier doesn't
work if the actions of Magneto don't
work then what we need is a mutant with
overwhelming Force leading a mutant with
just an insane amount of power an
overwhelming amount of power that can
essentially Crush everything in its path
that anything that comes its way will be
incinerated destroyed and and that'll be
the end of that what she does is she
allies herself with the villain
apocalypse and this is one of the
coolest things right because apocalypse
is a being of Darwinism he's social
Darwinism Only the Strong deserve to
survive the weak will make way for the
strong it's the natural order of things
now here's the important thing to
understand what Higman kind of says here
is like in this war that broke out
between humans and mutants this conflict
as it takes place in this timeline of
this life that she's lived instead of
humans making the first move it was
apocalypse who made the first move it
was more McTaggart going to instaban
newer and saying hey look here's how
everything is going to unfold here's
everything that's going to happen here's
all the things that I've tried I need
your help now and then apocalypse was
more like okay okay so if what humans
want is a war with mutant kind then we
will bring them a war we will give them
a war Without End we will test them
endlessly like we will constantly put
them in a situation where they're going
to have to do whatever it is they need
to do in order to win the danger in that
is that it basically presents a scenario
where apocalypse himself can be
destroyed and that's kind of what he's
looking for right he's kind of looking
for a scenario where Like Only the
Strong deserve to survive even if that
means that he becomes weak that means
that he becomes obsolete now he would
have to adapt and have to thrive in the
face of that but what you end up getting
here is in in the outset of this first
conflict when it all kind of came about
in Apocalypse and His Four Horsemen face
off Against Humanity they wiped them out
on every level everywhere they went
right like they killed all the
superheroes they wiped out every major
city in the United States and what you
had was what was left of humanity
banding together and then facing off
against them it created a whole new
level of Sentinels a whole new level of
machines and none of it worked none of
it worked at all at the end of the day
apocalypse just like so many other
villains before him so many other
mutants before him ended up falling and
ended up dying and Maura McTaggart was
Reborn yet again and so what this does
is this wraps us back around to the
modern day so the beginning of House of
X number one and so what this seems to
indicate is that this is the 11th life
of more McTaggart it's the 11th time
that she's gone to Charles Xavier it's
the 11th time that she's tried to find a
way to see if there's some kind of
balance that can be struck between
humans and mutants it's the 11th time
that she's gone down the path of
presumably leading to a future where
mutants and humans will go to war and
all the mutants will be destroyed it's
the 11th time she's done this and like
the 10 times before it she's trying to
find a way to see if it's possible to
make it work
okay so I am in Portland Oregon right
now and I feel like there's gonna be
some fans who are just like how come you
didn't do a fan meet up why didn't you
tell anybody again I'm actually on
vacation here and and again like the
audio is probably gonna be kind of
crappy uh it's just really echoey in
here I mean I'm in a hotel room so you
know what all you can you say I don't
have the sound treated space of my home
but in this one we're picking up with
powers of X now this one's kind of
interesting because there is some cool
stuff that happens here but the big
takeaway is actually one of the
informational pages that Jonathan
Hickman provides in the comic book
itself but one of the things this
focuses on is it focuses on how it is
that we kind of got to the present day
right like Charles Xavier and Magneto
teaming up and working together and
that's one of the cool things is because
when it came to this it's really Hickman
kind of reworking a lot of things
especially when you get to like when you
have X-Men year zero which is when the
X-Men initially formed then you have the
X-Men and the modern day and then you
have like the X-Men 100 years from now
and then like like the end of all things
like you know society and like a
thousand years or ten thousand years
whatever it is uh it's kind of cool to
see this this whole thing play out but
what we saw in House of X was more
McTaggart showing up and basically like
revealing the truth to Charles Xavier
that she had lived all these lives and
she had basically shown him like Hey
look this is the future that awaits the
X-Men right like there really does not
seem to be a scenario where like any of
you guys win the only way that seems to
work is where you and Magneto basically
work together because at this point with
these lies that she's lived it doesn't
look like she's experienced a reality
whereby Xavier and Magneto came together
for whatever reason really probably just
the core of their differences and belief
systems it always led to like the
destruction of the X-Men presumably
Charles Xavier first and then Magneto or
Magneto first and then Xavier whatever
the case happens to be and so because of
that Xavier basically shows up at at
Island M which is really more or less
seems to kind of be like a precursor to
janosha and then essentially like
reveals to the truth to him and says
look like in this world that we live in
there doesn't really seem to be a
circumstance whereby our ideologies will
work hand in hand right like we have two
diametrically opposing views on how it
is that all of mutant kind needs to be
dealt with in relation to like what's
going on in the world right now but but
at the end of the day what Maura
McTaggart showed me is that all of this
really seems to just kind of be going to
pot that if we're going to survive that
we have to work together and that's kind
of the important thing that that Xavier
points out here is that for him it's not
about survival really it's not about
like about Charles Xavier's survival
it's about basically creating a
Circumstance whereby the the mutant
population thrives and the mutant
population continues to live on Long
beyond the two of them and that's very
far-sighted it'd be very easy for him to
kind of sit down and say like I'm
worried about right now right it's what
is what most people do it's what you and
I do it's what the average person does
because of that like it's a really
really cool concept when you look at
this and then you kind of apply it to
the nature of mutant kind in the sense
that it's not really about Xavier or
Magneto that it's about the survival of
their race and so that's when when
Xavier basically says hey look let me
show you these thoughts that Maura
mctaggard gave me and Magneto allows it
to happen he's basically bombarded by
like all these different scenarios these
scenarios where he's destroyed by
Sentinels these scenarios where he's
captured by shield and held in stasis
and so ultimately it's Magneto coming to
grips with the fact that nothing he does
matters and that's a huge Revelation to
have to undertake is a huge Revelation
that ultimately everything that he does
is for naught that he basically ends up
getting destroyed that it's all just a
giant waste and that's kind of a big
thing it's a massive thing right like
imagine if you woke up tomorrow and you
found out that like like you never
amount to anything in your life how
crushing would that be now it's kind of
a a really like a really good way to
speak to Magneto's resolve when he
basically says okay fine this is how
things are then yes we'll work together
right it's not it's not rolling over
it's not giving up it's not saying well
whatever I guess it's just the way it
goes it's saying like Okay like we have
to work together we have to get this
going and so what it does is it jumps to
your tent jumps to the present day and
you end up having What's called the
mother mold now this is a this is an
interesting concept because in Marvel
you had Master mode for a long long time
and master mold was basically a sentinel
that created other Sentinels right it
was just it was this Ruby huge thing you
guys saw at maximum in the Animated
Series but it was this great great like
this huge robot that probably stood 500
feet tall and it basically just sat like
in this kind of chair that was built for
it and just pumped out Sentinels that's
all I did was just create Sentinels and
the result was that it was it was a much
faster and more efficient way of
building them than what was originally
done by Boulevard Trask where it was
just like building them in a giant
Factory and then taking a long time to
assemble them and all that kind of good
stuff and so what this is is basically
it's mother mold in a sense that it's a
master mold that makes other Master
molds and that's kind of a crazy thing
because what this means is that humanity
is rapidly gearing up for a war with
mutant con and that's what this means
that's really the big takeaway From This
Moment here is that when they basically
grab this information to a mystiking
company that we saw in House of X grab
this information and brought it to the
X-Men it's that exact piece of data
that's going on that basically humanity
is ramping up and stockpiling as many
arms and Armament as they possibly can
and that's basically the stance of
Xavier is we have to go here and we have
to destroy the mother mold otherwise
we're going to be painfully outmatched
right and it's kind of a cool thing
because this is very reminiscent of Days
of Future Past right I mean that's one
of the things we've talked about and
Days of Future Past the reason why the
Sentinels were able to overpower the
superhero community so readily was
because there were just so many of them
right I mean if you are somebody like
like Magneto and you have this power of
magnetism and suddenly he'd be met by
like a whole Fleet in Armada of like
plastic symbols and they were just
completely overwhelming with with
unrelenting Force so instead of it being
like Oh there's a mutant down there and
here's two or three Sentinels suddenly
it's like it's like two or three hundred
Sentinels but just or maybe like 20 or
30 or something like that but they all
just descend on you and it's just a war
of attrition right eventually you just
get worn down and that's the nature of
these things that's why that's why
Sentinels are so dangerous is because
they don't get tired they don't wear out
right I mean you can destroy them but
like they don't get exhausted they don't
run out of an energy Supply right
they're all like nuclear power their
energy can just kind of go on forever
and ever and ever and so again it's kind
of a crazy thing but from here we jump
to the Future and we basically pick up
with this piece of information that was
that was gathered by the forces in the
future and they're in turn getting ready
to launch their attack and that's one
thing I want you guys to notice is that
this is all about information
information being transferred from one
person to another right so it's the
information that Maureen McTaggart has
it's been given to Charles Xavier which
has now been given to Magneto and that's
how they work together then it's the
information of you know this governor
terminal facility that was accessed by
the by mystican and the Brotherhood of
evil mutants which was handed over to
Cyclops and Charles Xavier and now you
have this information from the future
which is handed over to none other than
apocalypse and it's kind of crazy
because now this means that apocalypse
is currently running the X-Men and it
really kind of begs the question of what
does that mean for the team because this
is 100 years from now we can largely
assume that the X-Men as we know them
are basically dead right like Charles
Xavier's dead Magneto is dead they're
all dead and gone and it's kind of a
cool thing here because this information
was where they were sent in there for
was a particular bit of information but
the problem was trying it was like
finding a needle in a haystack and this
huge catalog of data that exists out
there you have to go find this one thing
and that's like an impossible feat to
achieve right so what they did instead
instead of them going in there blind and
searching through all these files trying
to find a piece of information they can
steal the Codex decipher the Codex and
the Codex will say it's that way it's
right here it's it's in this location
and once they break it down and once
they decipher it then in turn they
realize where this piece of information
is and they have to go and access and
the problem is they had blackout of of
their group the one who was basically
whisked away she was the one that
basically made them invisible to the
machines so now they have to go in there
and then be seen and so essentially
they're going to go into this place
alarms are going to be blurry and they
have to fight their way in they have to
secure the information and then fight
their way out and as as Wolverine says
it's a death sentence but an apocalypse
speaks up and says no I will lead you
there and so what this looks like is
this looks like the precursor for the
future that we saw with Maura McTaggart
where like apocalypse is obliterated by
the forces of of humanity and that's
entirely possible here it's kind of a
cool and a crazy little thing here
because then what you do is you jump to
1 000 years into the future and you have
this kind of whatever this happens to be
whether it's humans or mutants or what
have you but basically like they're met
by this giant dark sphere right that
kind of shoots out this little black ink
or whatever it is and when it starts to
speak to them which is almost
reminiscent of the beyonders for those
of you guys who read Hickman's Avengers
and New Avengers when it starts to speak
to them what this being says is what
we're looking for is Ascension and
that's when things really begin to get
kind of crazy because what this does is
it breaks down into how Hickman defines
societies and Marvel Comics but based on
technology right it's one of the
important things here when he says you
know like societal intelligence one
that's a machine but notice all of this
is tied into a machine it's tied into
like robots and and so on and so forth
now this seems to be something that
carries over to like humans like
biological organisms and you probably
could but with regards to this it's like
a single machine a robot that has
average intelligence right so I think at
this point he's kind of making the
Assumption or just kind of going with
the idea of like artificial intelligence
meaning a machine that can think for
itself or at the very least maybe
something just like a baseline Sentinel
uh and then from there you have a hive
right so like a collection of machines
all sort of working together where it's
greater than the sum of its parts and
then you have your your intelligence now
intelligence is cool because this is
basically his way of saying the Supreme
intelligence is basically a robot and
it's kind of a cool thing right because
the Supreme intelligence really always
was the Supreme intelligence was always
a robot of sorts and so far as it was an
organism that was plugged into the
brains of hundreds of thousands if not
millions of the smartest people that
ever exist in the cree society and then
in turn it can make decisions according
up now it is biological and so far as
like there's blood and there's flesh and
different things like that like it can
bleed and so on but in terms of how it
functions it really is more machine in
the sense that like it's a singular
organism that exists out there and it's
an amalgam of a ton of other Minds that
it can use for its own purpose to
achieve a particular goal now from there
you move Beyond planetary and then you
start getting into Galactic and this is
when you get into things like the
technarch now the technarch is a really
really cool change by Jonathan Hickman
and the reason why is because this ties
directly into the tech narchy and then
Warlock and Magus and the reason why is
in the 1990s you had a character by the
name of warlock who was just kind of
like this really crazy looking guy in
terms of like you know this stuff
sticking out of him and so on and so
forth but the idea behind this was that
it showed up and actually had the
ability to convert any kind of substance
into a technarch like something it could
absorb right and so it was essentially
the son of what was called well I guess
a being called Magus who is like the
super powerful being and it was from a
planet I always called a catch I don't
know if that's really the correct way to
pronounce it and the result was that it
just kind of went forward and then
eventually became good guy and Ally of
the X-Men and so on and so forth and
maybe a lot of it was because of the
fact that like originally warlock was
like fleeing the the planet of his
father and so on and so forth what
Hickman's doing is coming along and
saying no none of that stuff that we've
seen is what we think it is instead uh
Warlock and Magus and the planet catch
and all that kind of stuff that's one
facet of a multitude of Concepts that
are called the Techno basically there's
a lot of different variations of warlock
out there there's a lot of different
variations of maggots out there and they
all come from a planet that's a
seemingly called a catch right so the
idea behind this is that they're not the
only ones out there the reason why we've
never seen them is because no technar
can see another technoc it's kind of
weird in terms of like how they were
designed and how they were how they were
created but the idea behind this is they
were made for the purpose of basically
going through and like removing life on
planets and the reason why is because
when it comes to the Phalanx themselves
and this is kind of interesting thing
too I want to talk about that here in a
second when it comes to the Phalanx the
way that Hickman really purports it is
that it's a group of organisms that go
around and essentially deem different
planets as worthy of being Incorporated
into their their group into their
Collective if you guys ever watch Star
Trek those who were deemed worthy are
absorbed into it those who are not
deemed worthy are wiped Away by the
Techno that's the purpose the technarch
serves and the reason why that matters
is because what Hickman says here is he
doesn't say the Phalanx is an
Interstellar Society he says a Phalanx
is an Interstellar society and that
wording is particularly important
because what this means is that it seems
as though the Phalanx is the highest
state of intelligence that a particular
organism can achieve a point in which
there is no differentiation between
machine and man instead it's just a
super high level of organism and the
result is that when he says a Phalanx
and he may just simply be saying it for
the sake of the explanation and there
really is only one Phalanx race out
there or it could be that this is simply
just a super high level of achievement
right only one group has achieved the
level of fan length so far but others
can follow if given enough time and it's
kind of a cool thing it's a really
really cool concept because it's a way
to sort of take this entire idea of like
like machines intelligence and so on and
so forth and just kind of roll it all
into like this really nice packaged
organized bundle and then send it off to
us as the reader I really dig it I'm
absolutely loving it
okay so getting into house of X part
three
um this story is amazing because what
this does is this really gives us like
the origin of the Nimrod from from date
I'm sorry from powers of X which really
sort of changes everything that we've
known about the Nimrod Sentinels which
is the other big thing Hickman takes
everything that we know about nimrods
and then turns it on his head and it's a
cool idea like I actually really really
dig what it is that he's doing here but
we'll make this all make sense
especially when we talk about master
modes when he gives us this kind of
hierarchy we'll do an explanation on him
you know on on the concept of a master
mode different things like that but this
initially picks up with Cyclops now
remember up until about issue number two
or really issue number three of powers
of X we didn't really know how
everything unfolded like it was really
Hickman just kind of setting the stage
and showing us what was going on the way
this works here is it seems as though
powers of X basically feeds into house
of X they're not two distinctly
different stories happening at the same
time it's not like one focuses on the
future the other one focuses on them on
the present day and the past instead
you're talking about like two things
like one that feeds the other and so
powers of X really seems to just kind of
follow the lives of Warren habit right I
mean issues one through three were
basically showing us the future where
apocalypse launches an attack against
the Sentinel bases of Earth in order to
capture information or to attain
information on the origin of nimrod
which is handed over to Maura McTaggart
and because every time she dies she goes
back to the moment when she was reborn
and lives her life over again what it's
done is it allows her to basically
gather as much information as she can to
ensure the future survival of mutants
right so she ended up taking the partial
information on the origin of nimrod and
then bring it bring it back with her so
that when she dies she has that
information when she reincarnates and
that's where we are right now in House
of X and so it's the X-Men basically
taking the information that was gained
by more mctaggard at the end of powers
of X number three and then launching an
attempt to destroy Nimrod before he's
ever really created where I'd like to
prevent his creation and it's kind of a
cool thing because Cyclops is scared out
of his wits right and that makes sense
because what you're talking about here
is you're talking about the ultimate
Sentinel it's a sentinel design to
basically counter all form of
superpowers and then destroy the those
superpowered beings right so while I
don't necessarily agree with a with a
with the idea that apocalypse cannot
defeat Nimrod at the same time it also
kind of makes sense right because it
would defeat the purpose of nimrod if
Nimrod somehow encountered a earth-based
being that he couldn't defeat but
basically is Magneto trying to assure
Cyclops you know at the end of the day
you're an idea the attempt to basically
keep the mutant population alive and so
even if you go here and even if you die
you will never truly die because one
ideas never die and as a founder of a
Nation Founders are never forgotten if
you end up perishing on this mission for
Generations from now people will
remember your name they'll remember the
effort you put in now for Cyclops it
actually works because what Hickman has
done and what really what's been going
on with Cyclops ever since his return
after the events of Phoenix Resurrection
is that he's gone back to being the guy
who Champions the cause of Charles
Xavier and so it's a cool little moment
here because it's basically Cyclops
saying yes like that works for me and so
what he ends up doing of course is
walking through one of these these
teleporters and traveling to the blue
area of the Moon and then in turn
speaking with the X-Men and letting them
know what's going on and that What's
Happening Here of course is as we're
aware there's there's orcas right this
government organization composed of a
myriad of different different groups
Hydra advanced I do mechanics things
like that it really serves a purpose of
basically just like coming together and
finding a way to control the mutant
threat right so like project wide awake
at its most extreme right like contain
control and if necessary eradicate the
mutant threat and so what Humanity's
been doing is they're creating a Mother
Mole designed to create other Master
molds for the purpose of basically
creating Sentinels at an exponential
rate and what Hickman does here is he
basically gives us this progression from
a baseline Sentinel to Nimrod what he
does is he kind of takes all the
information that we've had and and not
really flying in the face of it so much
is just kind of expanding it out so in
Marvel Comics for years and years and
years Nimrod was considered the ultimate
Sentinel right the idea was that in the
Days of Future Past timeline Sentinels
were constantly improving on themselves
right like creating new versions of
themselves until they got to the point
where they could create Nimrod a
sentinel that can shape-shift a sentinel
that can basically detect the weaknesses
of mutants and then use that to its
advantage that could detect their powers
and then find ways to overcome their
powers it could adapt it had all these
different capabilities all these things
that it could do that made it like this
living Powerhouse now now the way it was
originally designed uh nimrods were
governed by their programming right like
that was it it was simply their
programming and that's all there was to
it that changed when Nimrod came to the
to the main Marvel Universe left the
Days of Future Past universe and came to
the main Marvel Universe then it kind of
forgot its programming and went and
started doing what it thought was the
right thing to do which I think for a
little while was actually became not
really a hero but kind of an anti-hero
it was kind of weird the way that it
played out back in back in the day but
all Sentinels are basically governed by
programming and they couldn't deviate
beyond that programming what this does
is it says okay so there's your Baseline
Sentinel right so these are the ones
from Days of Future Past the ones that
you recognize from X-Men the Animated
Series these are your straight line
Sentinels the most popular versions of
of this you know this type of Machinery
then you go into Master molds and master
molds basically are replicating
machiners like they basically create
Sentinels that's their purpose right you
go back and you look at X-Men Issue
Number 15 they were created by Boulevard
Trask originally by Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby um and then in turn when Bolivar
trash was defeated the mastering role in
The Sentinel concept was handed over to
Stephen Lang and Steven Lang started
creating more similar right and the idea
behind this was that creating signals by
hand was too tedious and too time
consuming you know for ball of our trash
it simply just took too long so why not
create a giant machine that in turn will
create Sentinels create one like every
five to ten minutes or something along
those lines and basically just like
crank them out as fast as humanly
possible it was basically a way to mass
produce Sentinels at a very accelerated
rate now from from the master mold you
go into the motherboard which is what
Hickman is giving us here and a mother
mold is basically a replicating adaptive
signal Factory right it's basically a
master mold uh and it's self-aware like
a master mold is insofar that if there's
a scenario of danger and the master mold
cannot overcome that danger it will
leave and go somewhere else to where it
can start it can continue creating
Sentinels a mother mold will do the
exact same thing it'll do whatever it
needs to do to eliminate threats to its
existence so it can continue with its
programming and creating Sentinels and
the funny thing about this is that where
a master mold can never do anything but
make Sentinels a mother mold is believed
can actually progress to the point where
it can create something better than
Sentinels right it can create like
purely adaptable machines based on Nano
Sentinel technology that's what Hickman
tells us that basically it can create
Omega Sentinels and it can do this by
creating Nano by using like Nano
Sentinel Tech and putting it into into
human beings now Master Mold was
originally able to do that you know it
wasn't until the later years I guess not
really originally but it wasn't until
the later years when you got into like
the the late 90s and the early 2000s
that a master mold was able to do that
create like Omega Sentinels right so
really in the early to early 90s to the
early 2000s but this is something that
really seems to be ascribed explicitly
to the mother mold the mother mold is
the only one that can basically create
like Omega signals now from there you go
into the to the definition of an Omega
sound right and we've talked about that
before Omega signals are basically
humans that have been merged with Nano
Sentinel technology right so for those
of you guys who ever watched Star Trek
figure the Borg the difference is that
there is a kind of progression when it
comes to that and we'll talk about that
you know later on in this video but then
you go into basically a nimrod and this
is where Hickman is changing things
because instead of simply saying Nimrod
he's saying a nimrod and this is
basically a pure Nano Sentinel construct
right so anti-mutant adaptive self-aware
self-replicating virtually
indestructible what Hickman seems to be
saying here is that an Omega Sentinel is
The Logical conclusion to a nimrod right
so like depending on what's going on
that you basically have a baseline
Sentinel which in turn is created by
Master moles which in turn is created by
mother molds which are capable of
creating Omega Sentinels which will turn
into nimrods what he does next is he
basically says that a nimrod isn't is an
in-state it's a conclusion to the
progression of a Omega Sentinel it's
basically what that is and so it's kind
of a cool idea here because when you
look at this for what it is it turns
into this neat idea like this really
neat this really neat concept because
then he goes into the Omega Sentinel
process right like the the system by
which these Sentinels exist right and so
a person is initially infected and then
the Nano Sentinels basically infest the
human host right they basically start
replicating all over the place and
infest this person and then they lay
dormant for some time depending on when
it when it is they need to be activated
right so like when they're infected in
there like the motherboard May create
them and say okay these Sentinel genes
or these Sentinel uh Nano Sentinel Tech
pieces are going to become activated in
like 10 years right and then when that
happens they're basically activated or
it can activate them right off the spot
like like right off the bat whatever the
case is when activation takes place then
in turn like the person starts to become
converted right so activation happens
and then a union takes place right where
the human becomes aware of this you know
kind of voice in the back of their head
basically these Sentinel directives that
are being given to the Nano Sentinel
Tech inside their body and then in turn
the nanotech totally integrates into the
human being you know and it takes over
them and then eventually they're totally
a machine state right they're completely
and totally taken over by the nanotech
and there's no real shred of human being
left and they basically become a nimrod
it's cool like it's a it's a cool
concept but at this point we switch over
to what's called project Achilles now
project Achilles is kind of like this
government-sanctioned super villain
prison with regards to like mutants it
seems almost explicitly for mutants but
for individuals with superpowers right
so like the next stage of the raft
prison off the coast of New York or
whatever it was before it was destroyed
during the events of Brian Michael
business's New Avengers and so what
happens here is you basically have a
mutant that's brought before the chord
and essentially this is a kangaroo court
right like his guilt has already been
determined the Court's kind of like you
know what is what does a public defender
have to say but it doesn't really matter
right because it's like there's a 12
strikes Rule and the 12 strikes rule is
that if you commit an illegal act 12
times then regardless of your intention
whether you were tricked into it or not
you're thrown in jail and we end up
learning of course that this mutant is
none other than Sabertooth and it's kind
of cool because Sabertooth is like yeah
man I'm guilty like I've done all these
things like everything you accuse me of
I've done and I don't really regret it
like I'm not I don't really feel that
bad about it because like I mean what
does it matter like you got people here
with guns but I got a healing Factor who
cares I could tear through everybody in
this room it's one of the reasons why I
love Sabertooth Hickman is doing 1980s
Sabertooth let me tell you something
about 1980 saber tooth that version of
sabertooth back in the day he would have
killed everybody in this room and been
home in time for cornflakes they would
do he was he was awesome and so it's
it's this cool moment here because as
he's kind of sitting there like his of
course his senses pick up on the smell
of Jasmine and this entire court is met
by the arrival of Emma Frost and this is
probably one of the coolest moments in
the entire story because Emma Frost
comes walking in and this is kind of the
cool moment what I was expecting her to
do was shut down everyone right because
Emma Frost is an Omega Level telepath I
guess maybe now she's not really
considered a mega level according to
Jonathan Hickman but she's an
exceedingly powerful telepath she walks
in she can dominate the minds of
everybody in this room but she doesn't
instead she uses the law on her side and
the reason why is because if she walked
in here and dominated the minds of
everyone and then took Sabertooth it'd
be a prison break instead she comes out
and she says we as as krakowa are a
Sovereign Nation we enjoy diplomatic
immunity every mutant on the face of the
planet is a citizen of kirkoa therefore
every mutant on the face of the planet
has diplomatic immunity in human court
systems therefore you cannot put
Sabretooth on trial because he is
outside your purview he's Beyond you
right you can't you can't touch this guy
to hold him on trial is to do this
illegally like you're basically
committing an illegal act by doing this
and so it's kind of a funny little thing
because she's like we have all the
paperwork that you need or at least the
step for cocoons tell you know her her
clones basically are like we have all
the information that you need like we
have all the paperwork and everything
everything that we're doing is above
board we're not cheating the law we're
not skirting the rules or anything like
that everything we're doing here is in
the confines of the walk so legally you
have to release saber tooth or what
you're doing is defying the United the
United States defense department in
which case we'll take the whole thing to
court it's using the legal system as a
means to basically circumvent everything
and it's kind of funny because there's
this chick here who points a gun at Emma
Frost right and you know she says like
under any normal circumstance I would
basically trick you into believing that
well I won't go into that but basically
I would I would take away your ability
to shoot me
for lack of a better word and so it's
this amazing moment right because she's
like I've I've learned to understand the
diplomacy is really the way to go so
here's what we're gonna do if you're
gonna put your gun away and you're gonna
let me leave with Sabertooth and I'm
going to pretend like you could have
stopped me and like that'll be it dude
it's one of the coolest things right
because like this chick never could have
stopped Emma Frost Emma Frost could have
made this chick believe that she was a
rabbit and have her spend the rest of
her life hopping around on all four legs
right like eating carrots like that
would have been that would have been her
life from that point going forward right
like she would have spent the rest of
her life believing she was SpongeBob
SquarePants and walking around seeing
the theme song like Emma Frost could
totally scramble this chick's brain and
that's why it's so awesome is because I
love the way that Hickman writes this I
love the way Hickman does these things
and so what we end up doing is
transitioning to Orcas Fort now this is
one of the reasons why Hickman writing
is so awesome because everything
intertwines everything ties into
everything else that's why I like
truthfully speaking if all you wanted to
do was read Jonathan Hickman right you
start with uh his Fantastic Four run and
then you go into his secret Warriors you
can read Shield if you want to if you
want like basically the origins of
Shield and then you go into like like
Avengers and New Avengers you read all
those those books like if you read them
in chronological order it's one giant
cohesive story and it all fits in
perfect you could literally ignore
everything else than Marvel Comics and
like you would be fine he would not be
confused it would all make sense that's
why Hickman writing is so cool because
when you look at this you have these
panels they basically orbit the sun
those are the panels that Tony Stark was
working on during the incursions during
the events of Avengers and New Avengers
so it's kind of a cool thing here
because in turn what you have is you
basically have like like all of this
like Humanities basically built this
giant Forge in the wake of Saul's Hammer
that was basically the way it was like
Saul's Anvil was Fantastic Four Saul's
Hammer wasn't it was the name of the
giant Dyson Sphere that Tony Stark was
building around the Sun in order to like
destroy and curse of Earth during
Avengers New Avengers so again all of
Hickman's stuff builds onto itself the
issue with this is that while they're
working on building this giant Mother
Mole that's going to start creating
Master molds the problem they run into
is the X-Men arrive because what
Humanity did not count on was the X-Men
getting information from Warren
McTaggart from what was essentially of
the future in order to learn what it is
they're doing in the past and so they
they really kind of panic and they
really kind of freak out because they're
like we weren't expecting this now
remember Omega is still here which means
Omega of course she's the chick that
basically operates alongside Nimrod
during powers of X the one that you see
who's basically red with like the
Machinery looking stuff on her face
that's her the real question to ask here
and this is the big question that I want
to know if Hickman's going to answer can
you have more than one Nimrod is a
nimrod considered to be like a queen bee
or a B Hive right you can only ever have
one Queen I wonder if that's the case
like when it comes to Nimrod there's
only ever one Nimrod at a time I'm
curious if that's the case or not so of
course the X-Men basically trying to get
the information they need send in
Nightcrawler because Nightcrawler is the
best bet right he can teleport in
teleport around him you know Humanity
won't be able to catch up to him he can
ground the information he needs and you
can basically find a way for for the
X-Men like where they need to Dock and
where they need to get in and then in
turn they can launch their mission now
the funny thing about this is that the
X-Men are still trying to maintain this
idea that there are Innocents here that
they're basically like contractors
government workers different things like
that and so not everybody on this
facility is guilty but the reality is
that even if they're not necessarily
guilty like they're working alongside
the guilty party and so they're guilty
by association so you got to do you got
to do them away anyway you know it's
it's kind of the nature of the beast
that's the way it goes and so as a
result of this uh what you end up having
here is you end up having a guy named
Erasmus now Erasmus Mendel is like a new
guy here right like we don't really know
anything about him like I mean he's he's
literally introducing Hickman's uh House
of X Series and so usually Hickman does
things like this because they serve a
particular purpose in this instance like
Erasmus basically looks at that and it
says like they're basically getting
ready to board here we have to stop them
from being able to get information about
like the mother mold right because the
mother mode is currently learning it's
currently learning all these bits of
information and all these things so that
when Humanity activates it it doesn't do
Days of Future Past where it sits around
and says humans and mutants okay so
mutants come from humans therefore
mutants are human hence all humans and
humans need to be subjugated under the
power of the Sentinels because my
programming says mutants need to be
contained to control well mutants are
humans all humans and mutants get
contained and controlled instead of
having to move to that logical inclusion
it can use what's basically called
Nuance so it's kind of a cool little
thing here because up happening is
Erasmus basically says like we can't let
them win do not let the mutants get all
this information that they need and he
basically blows himself up and so what
this seems to do where at least he
detonates and and with the intention of
destroying the the X-Men the X-Men ship
what this seems to do is set the stage
for basically his wife becoming like
this new rabid anti-mutant supporter and
really kind of moving at moving forward
at a far more rapid pace and basically
speeding up the creation of the mother
mold in effect what this what this seems
to do is that by the X-Men launching
their attack and trying to find a way to
overtake and to take out the mother mold
what they've done is sped up their own
execution like their own destruction by
creating a far more rabid enemy than
they had before it's kind of cool and
it's a it's a pretty awesome concept
okay so we are getting back into powers
of X and here's this is why I love
Hickman writing right because there's
there's how you think everything is and
then there's the change right the shift
that basically changes the way you think
everything is so initially the way this
all popped off this seemed to be a
future where Mankind and machines you
know robots had basically worked
together and then in turn like wiped out
what was left of humanity what Hickman
tells us in this story is that it's not
that way that instead what basically
happened is somewhere along the line it
seemed as though man and machine had
basically started working together and
then essentially machine took over they
all took over and they all started
conquering everything and the result was
that mankind was forced into a situation
where either they had to flee for their
lives and survive as best they could or
they were converted into like cyborgs
which is cool because it didn't really
seem that way originally and this is a
funny thing about that is is you look at
things like Nimrod and it seems to be
like the most obvious circumstance right
like you go into the section and it
basically talks about the Temple of
concordance and the Church of ascendancy
and it's like you have to shed your
humanity and you have to like basically
become a better version of yourself you
essentially have to become part machine
it's kind of a crazy scenario because
there's a lot that's being borrowed here
over the course of like the publication
history of Marvel for example the idea
of X Factor in game the story where you
basically had the son of Cyclops and
Madeleine Pryor who went on to become
cable who was basically exposed to the
techno-organic virus and then in turn
became like half man half machine right
that's basically what's happening here
that human beings are being converted
into machines or achieving quote unquote
ascendancy is what this is called and so
you you look at this and it's like okay
so I guess this is basically where
things stand now and then you start
seeing themes like The Summer's
Rebellion you start seeing themes like
Days of Future Past now for those of you
guys who don't know what that means a
lot of you guys have probably heard of
Days of Future Past which is basically a
story where you ended up having
Sentinels who were who were sent on a
mission to essentially capture mutants
right you had the assassination of
Charles Xavier Moore McTaggart and
Senator Robert Kelly that led to the
president reinitiating The Sentinel
program the Sentinels became autonomous
it became self-aware and then basically
enslaved both humans and mutants in an
alternate reality that that is really
where the character a bishop comes from
you had the exact same process that led
to the Days of Future Past the
difference is you had what was called
The Summer's rebellion and The Summer's
Rebellion it was basically the humans
and the mutants working together and
then casting off the Sentinel threat
what seems to be in with a little
timelines that Hickman gives us he
doesn't really explicitly state it it
seems to be similar in that regard
insofar as Sentinel somewhere along the
line took over or at least machines and
man started merging and that's kind of
where we are now now again it was a
little a little more complex in terms of
like hounds and things like that we've
talked about that in the previous video
but it is a cool little thing because in
the middle of all this suddenly you're
met by the arrival of half the forces of
what's left of the mutant population now
this is one of the things that that
Hickman runs over right he basically
says the last surviving mutants that are
left on Earth that what you have here
above them all is you have Apocalypse
Now the way that Hickman describes this
is exceedingly important because what he
does is he lists apocalypse as an
external and this has been debated
multiple times over the years right is
apocalypse truly an external meaning is
he truly a legitimately Immortal immune
meaning he's immune to like aging and
disease it can be killed in the
conventional sense he will never age he
can't catch a cold he can never catch a
disease or anything like that is that
truly what he is and because Marvel
never really specified that because they
never explicitly told us that it was
always just kind of left up to
interpretation what Hickman says here is
no this is now fact apocalypse is an
external and then from there you start
going into basically his new four
horsemen right so you've got Wolverine
you've got Zorn you've got North and
then you've got like Cipher who's the
new famine now again when it comes to
the horsemen of apocalypse this is one
of the ways that things sort of change
here right like the horsemen of
apocalypse always seem to play like an
evil role right like they were bad guys
they would do the bidding of Apocalypse
but they were only ever really bad guys
by circumstance because they carried out
the bidding of apocalypse and Because
the bidding of Apocalypse usually ran
contrary to the X-Men's mission of being
humanitarians it basically made
apocalypse a bad guy and therefore by
that extension it made that it made the
horsemen bad guys at the end of the day
the horsemen just do what apocalypse
tells him to and so if apocalypse became
a you know became a good guy then the
horsemen would be good guys because they
would do what apocalypse told him to so
uh but then there also are are basically
a few who are dead here so for example
sailor Bell she was a black brain she
died in the first issue of powers of X
you've got Rasputin who's a combination
of different mutants so again like a
chimera meaning that she's basically a
combination of Quentin choir who was an
Omega Level telepath Rasputin the
brother of uh of Colossus as well as
Bane Kitty Pride x-23 you've got
Cardinal who's a combination of
Nightcrawler uh it seems like Jean Gray
these are combination of these various
characters but then of course Percival
is also dead and then you've got mother
who simply called acaba or mutant now
she's called a pure blood and this is
very important because the initial
indication was the only person to really
attain the leader of the mother of the
clanocabba was Rachel Summers the
daughter of Jean Gray and Scott Summers
from the days of future past and that
was my initial thought I was like okay
so basically we have Rachel Summers here
nope it's going to be somebody totally
different and it's actually going to be
a cool idea and I'll explain what what
all this means but what you end up doing
here is is picking up with like Nimrod
and in really kind of this discussion
you know with one of his folks where
they're basically talking about the
notion of like the Church of ascendancy
being on fire and so on and so forth and
Nimrod doesn't really care right nimrods
is kind of like my job is to figure out
what in the world it was these mutants
broke into the facility in the first
place for I don't really care about
something as small as a church of
ascendancy but it's one of these things
where he really kind of runs over this
idea that humans aren't really relevant
anymore this is when we start to sort of
get this discussion that there are kind
of like small little bands of humans
that still exist around on Earth but
there's no real connection between
themselves and mutants and so you would
think in the aftermath of essentially
this ascendancy right the aftermath of
humans who are being forcefully
converted into cyborgs through what was
left of humanity would band with what's
left of mutant kind and then try to
basically save the world but the point
is is that none of that really works
that's one of the things that Hickman
gave us in the timeline Avengers world
meaning all the various Avengers teams
around the world they're all dead right
like Thor's gone Captain America gone
Iron Man all those characters they're
all dead and gone all you have left is
just a smattering of mutants here and
there and that's really it it's really
kind of humanity and and the earth's
population in the traditional Sense on
its last legs and so that's why things
are kind of crazy because when you have
the forces of Magneto and all these guys
basically showing up here and kind of
wreaking havoc and and really offering
more of a distraction suddenly they're
met with like a basically an entire
Armada of Fleet of Sentinels now and
that's what we end up finding out that
again this is a distraction the actual
main run of the force here comes from
cocoa the living Island right the guy
who looked like Groot as well as
Wolverine and then apocalypse and
they're all here for the purpose of
attaining this information this archived
that basically gives us the origin of
nimrod and that's the cool thing because
with this origin of nimrod it basically
explains where he came from and how he
got here now this is why I say this
appears to kind of be the future in at
least in in the traditional tried and
true sense of the main Marvel Universe
right because with Hickman giving us
these timelines of more mctaggard you
know the first life and the second life
and the third life and so on and so
forth this all kind of seems to be the
absolute life either that or or there's
something else going on and then the
reason why I say that is when it comes
to the origin of nimrod again this all
stems from Days of Future Past right you
have the Days of Future Past timeline
which was believed to have been changed
when Katie Pride's mind was sent into
the past and then the assassination of
more McTaggart Senator Robert Kelly and
Charles Xavier never happened and so the
result was that when Rachel Summers
completed her Mission by sending Kitty
Pride's mind back and kitty Pride's mind
returned to the the data Future Past
Universe of course it became an
alternate reality right because you know
it's it's an alternate future now since
the main Marvel Universe future was
fixed but what this meant was that when
they started going through and trying to
find a way to destroy the Sentinel
threat they stumbled into a laboratory
where Nimrod was being made and so when
Nimrod obliterated the two of them
Nimrod left that Dimension and showed up
in the main Marvel Universe and he'd
been there for quite some time and he
never went back right he never went back
to the Days of Future Past universe and
so that's why you look at this and you
say if we're talking about a universe or
at some point in the future Nimrod
basically initiates this ascendancy
where human beings are converted into
cyborgs that mutants are taken and
they're converted into into cyborgs that
hunt other mutants then nimrods
basically conquered the world and if
nimrods conquered the world then this
has to be Nimrod from Days of Future
Past meaning if he never went back to
that Universe this is the main Marvel
Universe now we won't know for certain
until Hickman basically confirms it and
verifies it and tells us definitively
this is the case but something that I
want you guys to notice here and it's
kind of intriguing I don't know if
there's a direct correlation here but
there seems to be some kind of some kind
of matching point between the number of
universes that we've had that have ever
existed starting with the first
firmament going forward and in the lives
of more McTaggart right I mean I don't
know if that's an absolute certainty
technically it's the eighth universe but
you can also consider the universe
before all things to be the first
Universe right so start with zero and
then work your way forward it's kind of
interesting here in terms of how this
how this all works out but the fact
remains here that what you're talking
about is Nimrod basically showing up
when he realizes that the X-Men have
essentially captured this bit of
information that contains his origin and
he absolutely unleashes holy hell on
these guys right like they're destroyed
by the Seminoles right I mean Rasputin
she literally rips the mask off of Zorn
which reveals the singularity inside his
head right the fact that he has a giant
you know a black hole in his head and
when she pulls that off it just starts
sucking everything around it basically
destroys everything that's there but
with Nimrod and his guys apocalypse
basically tells the Wolverine take this
thing and leave right like take this
this artifact and get out of here get
back to you know get back to mother
akaba I will take care of everything and
and it's kind of a cool thing because on
the surface you would kind of expect
apocalypse to be able to stand a chance
right I mean you're talking about a guy
who can give himself any superhuman
power who can grow to any size who can
turn his arms and legs and any extremity
he's a telepath he's a telekinetic he's
a Powerhouse and you would expect that
like he'd be able to take this on no
he's absolutely thrashed by by Nimrod I
mean and it's not even close this guy
could grow to like 2 000 feet tall he
could grow bigger than Galactus if he
wanted to he would expect him to be able
to do something like that but he's taken
out like that quick fast and in a hurry
and is totally obliterated by by Nimrod
who basically creates kind of like
duplicates of himself now of course
apocalypse was able to destroy one of
them but he's totally crushed here and
this is when you end up learning this
universe is the universe where
apocalypse led the X-Men in their war
against the mutant machine hierarchy and
ultimately apocalypse and all the X-Men
were defeated and the mother akaba the
the person who was running this whole
show here is actually more McTaggart
herself who's been injured and kind of
just stuck in this catatonic State and
this is a cool thing because what this
does is it allows Wolverine to put this
piece of information inside of Mora so
that when she dies and she basically
goes back and she lives her 10th life
she takes this piece of information with
her what seems to be going on here with
more mctagon this is a genius move which
seems to be going on here is that she
really is trying to find a way to ensure
that mutants survive you know into the
future and they're not wiped out by
humanity and so what she's doing is
she's going through every single one of
these lives that she's lived and she's
basically finding ways to amass huge
quantities of information so that every
single time one of these threats pops up
she immediately knows how to deal with
it she immediately knows how to cope
with it right because what they have
right now is the origin of nimrod and so
if her going through and preventing this
origin from happening keeps Nimrod from
arriving something else may take place
but what it does mean is they know his
weaknesses they know how to they know
how to take him out so that by the time
he pops up it doesn't take them by
surprise and so it's awesome to to kind
of see this unfold this is why I love
Jonathan Hickman writing right I mean I
think this universe is probably the most
interesting you know it's probably the
most intriguing of the the various lives
that she's lived of course we still
don't know anything about about life six
which I'm I'm kind of curious I feel
like that's going to be days of future
past but I'm not 100 sure but it's still
a pretty badass story
okay so we're getting into house of X
part four and here is the deal if this
is the fourth issue I don't even want to
see what the finale is like like I don't
even want to know like dude the finale
is going to be insane because this is
Jonathan Hickman this is amazing okay
okay so uh man let me show you something
all right here's the thing so so this
initially picks up with the other side
of the mission to the mother mold right
we talked about the mother mold being
the Sentinel that would create other
Master modes right it was a way to just
exponentially create a huge amount of
Sentinels and an exceedingly short
amount of time what this does is where
you have the X-Men launching the mission
near the Sun at the old Dyson Sphere as
it was created by Tony Stark during
Hickman's run on Avengers and New
Avengers what you have here is you have
storm and you've got magic and you've
got Xavier and you've got Magneto who
are communicating with them from Earth
from the other side and that's the big
question that's asked here because one
of the cool things that goes on is you
actually see a kind of melding of Minds
coming together now this is not uncommon
what's going on here is they're
basically daisy chaining everybody
together right so you've got Magneto
you've got B you've got a storm you've
got you've got magic you've got all
these different characters gathered
together and all their minds are going
to link telepathically and they're going
to communicate with Jean Gray and the
reason why is because this is an
astronomical distance for the most part
I mean given the entire scope of the
universe it's uh step out the front door
but in terms of the the distance between
the Earth and the Sun it's a huge amount
of distance especially for characters
trying to communicate telepathically
remember when you're talking about
someone like Charles Xavier somebody
like Emma Frost and Jean Gray without
the Phoenix Force they're basically
earth-based telepaths right they can't
really communicate to people on other
planets that's really reserved more for
somebody who's in possession of like the
Mind Stone from The Infinity Gauntlet or
something like that and so it really
does take all this mental energy to be
able to pull all this off and to be able
to communicate with Gene and what we end
up finding out is that when the bomb was
detonated by Gregor the head of security
at the time that basically it's caused
absolute Havoc for the X-Men right like
they ended up losing Archangel and husk
right so both those characters are dead
like it's crazy to see Archangel just
die like that but it's it's
it gets crazy uh like like here's the
funny thing about Wolverine when I first
looked at this I was like did Jonathan
Hickman really show Wolverine's arm
being cut off because he has adamantium
if you look close enough there's a bone
so like his arm's not actually cut off
it's just mangled really bad
but basically like the the X-Men team uh
this field team is has pretty much been
decimated that's kind of a crazy thing
because Hickman is sort of looking at
this and saying okay how can we make
situation dire for this right because if
you go and you look at almost anybody's
X-Men run outside of Chris Claremont
Chris Claremont would have done this
this is exactly what Chris Claremont
would have done he would have had the
X-Men go on this ship he would have had
the people on the ship respawn and in
kind and then he would have shown the
X-Men decimated right like just their
ranks not really all of them being
massacred but certainly all them being
like severely injured or something like
that you don't really see that in modern
day like he it's it's kind of crazy you
you look at certain things and you see
it from time to time but you don't
really see it see a scenario where it's
like okay so this is basically the Last
Stand of the X-Men you never really see
that and so it was kind of cool to see
Hickman doing this showing us how dire
things really are for the team but at
the end of the day the mission has to go
on and so when the question is asked of
of you know of Jean Gray you know or I
guess ass of all the other X-Men through
Jean Gray who's being communicated to by
you know Professor Xavier used in the
minds of the other X-Men on Earth can
the mission go on the response to
Cyclops is yes now this is where
Jonathan Hickman shines when it comes to
writing Cyclops and this is where
Cyclops fans get their due let's talk
about this for a second let's talk about
Cyclops Cyclops fans have really just
kind of been screwed for like the last
few years or so and I understand where
they're coming from because while I'm
not the most hardcore fan of Cyclops I
am a fan of the X-Men my my favorite
X-Men like my favorite well I'm not
gonna tell you my favorite X-Man is I
want you guys to Guess Who my favorite
X-Man is I'm curious to see if any of
you guys can get it right uh because
it'll be it'll probably be it and it'll
probably end up being like a crazy guess
if anybody gets it right I'll be amazed
but nonetheless like Cyclops fans have
been left hanging over the years right
because like Cyclops was killed and like
they got the crappy young Cyclops from
the bendus run and nobody wanted him
that character sucked people wanted like
the old school boy scout Cyclops and it
was cool to see his character's
evolvement right where he went from
being like the guy who always believed
in Xavier's dreams or the guy who
basically became the new Magneto like I
I love that version of his character but
Cyclops fans have kind of been screwed
and this is a great moment because this
is a tribute to the Cyclops fans because
during the old school Chris Claremont
era and even during like the stand the
the Stanley Jack Kirby era the Roy
Thomas era the Arnold Drake era Grant
Morrison you go to Chuck Austin you go
through like all these different eras of
the X-Men and this this is classic
Cyclops and it's the one that people
have really wanted to see come back for
quite some time because he is the guy
who would say we're all probably gonna
die here but so long as the mission
succeeds that's all that matters because
more important than any one man is the
mission and the MU the future of mutant
that's what I love about the
character of Cyclops and so ultimately
he basically says we're gonna split up
we're gonna go to different locations
right we're all gonna go to different
sections and we're basically going to
destroy these giant devices that are
holding the mother mold in place right
because the idea is to release those
devices and the mother mold will just go
crashing down into the Sun and that'll
basically be the end of it and it's
pretty cool the way it happens right
because then you've got the wife of
Gregor who we talked about in the last
video you got her who's basically
freaking out because her husband
sacrifices life and so when this when
this happens she's basically told look I
can't really order you to do anything I
can't really tell you what you can and
can't do but what I can say is if you do
nothing then your husband sacrifices
life for nothing so do something because
it's the only way to really redeem your
husband's sacrifice here and so that's
when this battle is found on two fronts
because on the surface we would say Okay
it'd be a silly move for her to go after
the the X-Men ship that's basically
attached to the mother mold you know
mother mold satellite it would make a
whole lot of sense because none of the
X-Men are really there but what it does
do is it gives them a place to basically
Retreat to and possibly an outdoor place
to make their last stand her response is
get rid of it Scuttle the ship so
they're stuck here there's no way for
them to get back right and it's kind of
cool because remember Nightcrawler can't
teleport that far Knight crawler can't
teleport from like the earth to the moon
or something like that his powers aren't
that aren't that developed but within
the time frame that it takes for
Gregor's wife you know this scientist to
basically commune and figure out what it
is they want to do two of these brackets
are deactivated they've got two more
left and it's kind of crazy and it gets
super cool because what it does is it
switches back over to the ship itself
and then it picks up with Monet Saint
Croix now of course we've explained
Monet saying Troy in the Generation X
video so I'll link that down in the
description but she's basically two
people in one that's that's really what
it is with her but she also does have
like that crazy Penance look right when
she when I think is when she becomes
Penance it's her history is so crazy and
so murky the reason why they did what
they did with with her was because they
were trying to find a way to make
Generation X relevant going into like
everything after issue number 21 and so
like it didn't work
time but like nobody cared about Monet
Sanctuary the long and short of it is
she's exceedingly capable right so I
mean she literally puts Jean Gray in the
in the Escape pod and then scuttles the
Escape pod sends it flying out into
space and basically says like she's
gonna take everybody else on her own and
of course she's completely destroyed
this switches over to mystique and this
blew me away right because Mystique goes
into that one section they chose
Mystique for that area because she can
shape-shift right so she can just look
like one of the scientists the issue is
as soon as she gets in she's met by the
doctor's wife and what this chick does
is open up one of the uh open up one of
the airlocks and suck Mystique out into
space right so Mystique is gone like
she's dead and it's just like like dude
they're they're falling dude they're
dropping like flies man like the X-Men
are just dropping like flies and it's
the craziest thing right because like
from there like it's basically Hickman
telling us like it's the last stand
right because what the what the
scientist ends up doing is she brings
mother mold online now this is a
dangerous game because remember with
these Sentinels they are technically
designed to be characters that have an
artificial intelligence right now their
artificial intelligence can't really
deviate past its own programming which
really kind of seems to be a uh like it
doesn't really seem to make any sense
right it kind of seems to just be a
direct contradiction with itself but
it's basically this idea that it can
think and function within the realm of
its programming the issue with this is
they don't know how its programming is
going to going to like evolve and grow
right I mean like you're talking about a
computer system so all this thing needs
to do is come online and in the span of
seconds loses mind destroy the entire
ship and then who knows what would
happen after that that's the fear they
have they don't know if it's going to be
sane or if it's going to be insane if
it's going to be like I am mother mold I
make Matt I make Master modes and that's
it or if it's gonna be like I am mother
mold everyone's gonna die like we don't
we don't know if that's what's gonna
happen
we don't know if that's going to be the
case or not and it's a gamble but the
crazy thing about this is that with
Mother mold coming on in 10 seconds the
X-Men have to disengage this last device
right but the issue is that the open
airlock is on the other side which means
they have to find a way to get out there
deactivated to shut it down and then
leave and it all comes down to Wolverine
It's the Last Stand of Wolverine and
this is the coolest thing ever because
if there's anything that Jonathan
Hickman is good at it's sending
characters out on one hell of a bank he
is amazing at doing that right like it's
heated it during during the Fantastic
Four he did it during Avengers and New
Avengers like he did it during all these
characters like like you guys remember
from Avengers New Avengers when Hyperion
and Thor died oh dude it was a dude it
was the craziest thing ever it was like
dude like Hyperion was like we're gonna
die here today and Thor's like yes but
if we're gonna die we're gonna die A
Warrior's death you know and it's like
it's the craziest thing hyperion's like
he's like I will see you in Valhalla and
Thor's like brother today I will race
you there they just go like racing up
against these beyonders they get totally
obliterated it's like it's like there
was a crack of thunder and something
else and then silence and it's just like
holy sh Nikes man it was it was insane
like it was one of the coolest things
Hickman is so good about that right
because do you end up having this
conversation between Wolverine and
Nightcrawler and and Wolverine just kind
of like do you think there's anything
for me after this like like do you think
there's anything in the afterlife
waiting for me it's a vulnerable
Wolverine right because the way that
Hickman writes it is kind of over and
covering it up with I'm just sort of
curious but he's not he's kind of like
I'm gonna die here like I'm I'm gonna
die in this place there's no real way
for me to come back I'm gonna be stuck
out in space I'm Gonna Be incinerated by
the sun there's not gonna be any way for
me to return from this so like do you
think there's an afterlife for me and
it's the cool it's one of the coolest
most touchy moments because Nightcrawler
tells them when you wake from this
Earthly Slumber my friend I will be
there waiting for you radiant and with
open arms and it's just like like from
that point he teleport teleports
Wolverine out there right because like
Nightcrawler burns up in the sun he's
got to go there to get Wolverine to that
location so Nightcrawler burns up in the
sun's heat Wolverine's skin is literally
melting off of his off of his adamantium
skeleton which is gonna be the only
thing left and he's just like hacking
and slashing away at this thing manages
to destroy it and falls into the sun
falls into the sun with the mother mold
and like it's one of the coolest things
as that's happening he's still like
slashing away at mother mold's face as
he crashes down into the sun it's the
most badass thing I've ever seen in my
life man let me show you something
man I'm gonna tell you something man
Jonathan Hickman Running Man John in the
Hickman writing it's the craziest thing
because from that point then it picks up
on cyclops trying to make his Escape
Cyclops is shot in the back the EXO the
the nanites end up traveling through his
body and into his brain and it's the
craziest thing because when he's
basically saying when he's talking to
the scientist and he's like he's like
Hatchery me doesn't mean anything her
response is we're not capturing anybody
today you guys killed my husband you're
gonna die and and cyclops gets shot in
the face and dies all the X-Men sent on
this Mission die every single one of
them die it's the craziest thing ever
because now what we get and this is this
is this is going to be a sight to behold
now what we get is the wrath of Charles
Xavier and the wrath of Magneto and I am
hyped to see what that looks like
okay so you guys are going to bear with
me for a second it might be a little bit
echoey in here and I'll try my best to
reduce it but I'm actually working on my
sound recording space at the moment so
we got to make do
but we are covering powers of X those of
you guys who are following me on Twitter
you guys know that I was taking a break
for this week but I'm doing powers of X
because I love House of powers of X now
where househood X covers the 10th life
of more mctaggard basically powers of X
covers a tin like not really a 10-year
window a uh covers three different time
periods right so the point at which the
X-Men were being formed or at least when
Xavier was trying to bring the team
together before it really officially
formed and then the second era is
basically the modern day and then the
third era is in the future now one thing
we've never actually done here is we
haven't actually established a
chronological time period of when this
takes place right I mean for the sake of
the story Hickman's just using a general
period of time like between this point
and this point is basically when
everything takes place that way he's not
really forced to narrow things down and
force it into a chronological period
because then it would all kind of go to
Pieces later on down the line Marvel
also kind of makes an editorial mandate
as far as I'm aware you can't really
ascribe dates to Comics otherwise it
actually puts a solidified date on them
uh whereas you can simply just say it
takes place somewhere maybe around the
modern day who knows and just kind of
call it day which is what they really do
now Charles Xavier served in the Korean
War which lasted Loosely between 1950
and 1953 right I mean it's a give or
take you know a few months here and
there in terms of the beginning and the
end but we can usually say at some point
in 1953 is basically when it came to an
end and then from there we basically
have what's around a maybe an 11 year
window not really an 11 year window
probably a a nine year eight or nine
year window between the time the Korean
war ended and the time Xavier started
the X-Men now before Hickman started
writing the writing the comics as they
exists now the explanation that Marvel
gave us in terms of why Xavier started
the X-Men in the first place was because
of the fact that he met Amal farook he
met the Shadow King and it was his first
introduction into a mutant that was
literally just malevolent right it was
just an evil entity that existed out
there and didn't want to do anything but
inflict harm on people and realizing
that that was you know that it would
make no sense to Simply assume it was
the only one and drawing The Logical
conclusion that there's other mutants
out there that would try to pursue the
same goal right world domination or just
inflicting harm or whatever Xavier
launched the X-Men and so what we're
looking at here is some time during this
eight year window between
1953-54 running all the way up to around
1961 62 so we probably said about nine
years uh when the X-Men were basically
introduced in Marvel Comics right or at
least when the team was officially
formed right because when the comic
first picked up the team had already
been formed so we can we can kind of say
somewhere along those lines and this
eight year window is when all this takes
place but what this does you know where
it says X-Men zero X-Men year one ah
this basically picks up with them going
to visit bar Sinister now again this is
Hickman referencing his own work bar
Sinister was given to us as part of
Secret Wars right when you had like a
battle world and you had the the realm
where Sinister hung out his base of
operations more or less it was called
bar Sinister so it was kind of cool to
see because what you also get here are
all these different versions of sinister
himself now this is something Jonathan
Hickman does not explain those of you
guys who read Secret Wars and who read
Avengers New Avengers can hearken back
to this but the only real conclusion we
can draw from this is that either these
are clones that Sinister made of himself
or they're the alternate reality
counterparts who have just been here
ever since now you have these different
versions of himself and then you have
the actual Nathaniel Essex who seems to
be be the one sitting here this is kind
of a big moment here and it's kind of a
big thing because what Hickman does is
change up pretty much everything we know
about Nathaniel Essex and he says that
he has a mutant Gene this is wholly new
territory this is Jonathan Hickman
shifting things up entirely but for
sinister himself a little bit of
backstory here and you guys will find a
link in the description for Mr Sinister
explained which again is part of our
X-Men playlist our X-Men encyclopedia to
basically sum this up Sinister used to
be called a guy named Nathaniel Essex
and the idea was that he was he was
obsessed with genealogy right he was
obsessed with the idea that somewhere
along the line that that humans were
going to give way to people with
abilities right so it was basically the
concept of mutants but not really
knowing what it was it was something
just a theory that he had but because of
the fact that the villain apocalypse
didn't really even know what he was and
then overheard the theories of sinister
and then was basically told you're a
mutant right you're the next stage in
human evolution in response the question
was asked do you want to be able to do
this kind of stuff forever and when the
answer was yes then you ended up having
apocalypse who uses technology to
transform Nathaniel Essex into Mr
Sinister right so up until this point
this particular comic right now the form
and function of sinister's powers is
that they were bestowed on him by
external means by you know apocalypse
using Celestial technology to modify the
genes of Nathaniel Essex what Hickman is
doing here is saying no that basically
either he's going to reconcile the two
and say that what apocalypse did was
wake up the mutant Gene of Nathaniel
Essex or he's going to come back and
he's gonna say that never happened but
then basically meeting with Sinister is
interesting here because Xavier shows up
and he basically says we know that what
you're doing right now is going through
and cataloging the world's DNA right
that's what Sinister does he looks at
the entire world's population and says
who's a particular interest here
basically it's it's Professor X and
Magneto simply saying we know that you
catalog mutant genes and even just human
genes to a degree we know that you're a
collector these are things that are of
interest to you so what we want to do
here is we want to work with you we
basically want to bring you the entire
catalog of the mutant genealogy as we
discover it you will be the one who will
catalog it you'll hold on to it you'll
examine it you can do whatever you want
with it just don't destroy the genes and
don't you know do anything like
nefarious you don't like clone people or
anything which is what he did with Jean
Gray he made Madeline Pryor but uh but
the fact remains you know they're like
basically you're going to be the
database management for the entirety of
the X-Men population or at least the
mutant population and where this version
of sinister basically shuts it down and
says why would I want to work with any
of you on on this particular thing he's
basically killed from behind and we're
met with the real Nathaniel Essex now
this is kind of like a big change in
terms of Nathaniel Essex as we know him
because he's kind of depicted more is
like uh well there's really no better
way to say it um he's sassy that's
basically what he is you know like it's
me Mr Sinister
I'm fabulous uh it's it's kind of what
it seems like you know and I think it's
kind of cool actually I think it's kind
of interesting but it's a pretty cool
thing because what this does is this
sets the stage that where we previously
looked at all the X-Men stories that
came before powers and House of X and we
saw Mr Sinister as a guy who was
collecting the DNA of mutants by using
subterfuge right like doing in a very
very sneaky way in a very underhanded
way basically doing what he was not
supposed to do what we're finding out
here is that Xavier basically send him
on that path and then this has all been
happening at the hands of Xavier which
is again a pretty cool concept and so
what this does is this switches over to
uh to Doug Ramsey and it switches over
to Xavier and basically Xavier kind of
again setting in motion all the things
that are going on right now with the
establishment of krakowa as being a
mutant Haven now up until this point um
and this is kind of an interesting thing
here because when when this happens and
we basically get you know a few a few
months ago when we speed up to what's
basically a few months before the events
of of the modern day picked up with
regards to to house and powers of X we
end up finding that Xavier traveled back
to krakowa now krakowa had had always
kind of been an enemy Island more or
less of the X-Men and so far that it was
it was a giant size X-Men story right
like this story where they all kind of
came together and they had to save the
X-Men from cocoa and all that kind of
good stuff one of the cool things that
Hickman does about this is he actually
says it's not really what we think it is
right in the sense that krakowa is there
but it's not really a malevolent Island
it's not an evil place it's an island
that's there and it never really had any
true contact or at least in it in its
present form never really seemed to have
any true content attack with beans that
were out there and was really more
Curious than anything else and so what
he basically does is he brings Cipher
along for the purpose of being able to
understand krikowa and the reason why
this matters is because where Xavier can
tap into gracoa and Xavier can
understand the more empathetic
Tendencies right in the sense of
walkerco is feeling and and how it's
perceiving things Doug Ramsey again as a
mutant that can basically speak any
language can essentially understand the
language of garcoa as it talks and then
turn it and you'll create an alphabet
more or less and then pass that on in in
the form of Xavier absorbing it and then
setting it up so every mutant could
understand that's really kind of how all
that worked that basically the way this
played out is in the modern day the
various X-Men who want to escape human
persecution more or less who want to go
to a safe place we'll go to Cocoa but
the question was always asked if gracoa
speaks a language that nobody on Earth
understands then how do they understand
it this is where that begins that is
Douglas Ramsey sitting down it's Douglas
Ramsey learning to understand the
language having a full-on conversation
spending about a year to really grasp
how it is that rakoa talks you know it's
like learning French or Spanish or
something like that and then in turn
what Xavier does is he takes that
information and he copies it out of the
mind of of Doug Ramsay and then from
there the various telepaths stationed
around krakowa install that language for
lack of a better word into the mind of
New Mutants so they understand exactly
what it is Circa Co is saying and how
the island functions it's a pretty cool
thing here now from there it jumps into
the origin of krakowa itself in terms of
of what karcoa was before it became the
land mass that it is now but what we're
told here is that at some point in the
past there was simply just a land called
okara and the way it's described here by
Hickman is a little interesting uh but
also a little strange at the same time
right because this land is described as
being ancient before the word existed
but not old in the way that you know
that that they were old that like the
world itself is old meaning that this
island existed but like either it was
artificially created or it rose up
somewhere along the line I would say
this chunk of land mass probably rose up
sometime during the Great cataclysm
right when the celestial showed up
during the second host they wiped out
most of the deviants they sunk Atlantis
that somehow this popped up in the
process right it's really little way to
make it make sense and the reason why
that why I say that is because somewhere
along the line This land mass of a car
was split in half and it became or Rocco
and krakowa and from this giant Rift
more or less between these these two
chunks of land uh came these massive
demons right this Twilight sword
basically came with them now the
Twilight sword is interesting because on
one hand it kind of looks like the all
black necro sword but it's not so we
know this is not null the god board I'm
sorry I know the the Symbiote God right
and then my thought was well if it's
being called the Twilight sword then
maybe it's a Twilight sword of certain
the issue is that the Twilight sword of
server looks a little bit different the
reality here is we're not given an
explicit explanation what these guys are
all we're told is that these demons
these monsters more or less showed up
out of this Rift and then ultimately
they were fought by the apocalypse and
this is why I say this takes place
probably somewhere around four four
thousand to 4 500 years ago right
because apocalypse was born 5 000 years
before the modern day and he didn't rise
to prominence until around maybe 100
years after that after everything thing
that took place in Egypt right so maybe
around 4 900 years ago is when this may
or may not take place right so we've got
an almost 5 000 year window between when
this happened right so if we scale it
down and go by what we're being told
maybe anywhere between four to um sorry
five to four thousand years before the
modern day but regardless it took place
a long time ago and we don't really know
what these beings are and in fact all
we're really told here is that by virtue
of Apocalypse defeating these forces and
then casting them back down into the
cavern and then cutting off that entire
section of krakowa from itself vicarco
has kind of been half an island ever
since and it always will be forever
right it's not it doesn't really seem to
be super important at the moment but
that's the nature of Jonathan Hickman
writing he gives you something that
seems pretty innocuous right it's just a
thing that's there and then suddenly it
becomes super important in like 20
issues right so that's one of these
reasons why when you're going out and
buying and you're reading these stories
you have to pay attention to everything
ultimately what ends up happening here
is is Douglas Ramsey staves on stays on
on krakowa for about a year and then
basically goes to the process of
understanding how it all works and so
what we do to this point is we jump to
the the future and we talk about this
concept of of basically Ascension now
remember from what we saw in the last uh
the last issue Ascension is basically
like this sort of final step for those
individuals who are essentially robots
right like the idea is that when a
robot's created you know with a baseline
Sentinel is really where Hickman starts
from you go from a baseline Sentinel
which is given a command and the command
is basically eliminate mutants now it
follows that command to the best of its
ability and is given a little bit of
leeway there right insofar is like a
sentinel would look at a mute and say
okay mutants are the enemy but mutants
stem from humans because of the next
step in human evolution therefore all
mutants have the potential to become
mutants and so all humans are enemies
like that's the kind of conclusion that
a that a sentinel withdrawal right but
only insofar as the command that it's
given right it wouldn't say like your
job is to take care of like all all
mutants like a a sentinel wouldn't look
at that and extrapolate and say okay
because there's there's humans then
there's humanoids we should also take
out humanoids no it's confined to that
line of programming beyond that you go
into Master mode which is given a little
bit more of of leeway in terms Sentinels
in terms of how it creates them as well
as like getting up and leaving and going
to a safe place if it's in danger but
it's still continually following the
program of my job is to create Sentinels
then you go into a mother mold which is
a little more intelligent than you go
into a nimrod which is artificial
intelligence and then you go into what
are basically humans that are bonded
with nanites and become like the perfect
sort of Sentinel but the issue with this
and this is one of the things that
Hickman kind of points out here is that
this ascendancy that's currently taking
place right now this landscape in you
know a thousand years in the future what
we found out in the last video is that
these aren't humans and they're not
mutants that humans and mutants have
essentially been wiped out or pushed to
the brink of Extinction mutants for the
most part seem to be gone almost
entirely what's left of them exists way
out there in the far reaches of space is
part of the Shia Empire those who are
left on Earth and there's there's
probably around eight or nine of them
they're the only ones really left in
this part of the universe uh from there
you you basically look at humans and
what we were told here is that humans
kind of exist in small little
encampments but they're more fleeing for
their lives and trying not to be caught
but what you have now basically running
the show are these human and and robots
hybrids right these these sort of
perfect beings these Omega Sentinels
more or less is what they're called that
exists out there the issue they're
running into here is that when the
Phalanx show up and they're trying to
reach ascendancy the goal of the
phalanes is to basically look around at
all machine Concepts right like all
robots who have achieved a higher level
of other artificial intelligence that
basically allows them to transcend their
programming and even transcend Humanity
right to think far beyond the means of a
normal human but to also somewhat
function as humans and then absorb them
into themselves if they're far enough
along if they're of Interest right
that's basically what it is the issue
with this is that they're not fully
robotic and so one of the ways they're
trying to get around that and this is
kind of where this comic ends one of the
ways you're trying to get around that is
they're actually trying to essentially
take their Consciousness and then put it
inside a computer shell and then when
that's done the Phalanx will see that
computer shell and then say okay like we
will absorb that because as far as the
Phalanx are aware this is a being this
achieved I guess a machine is achieved a
higher level of thinking that really
seems to be what's going on here but
again this is classic Hickman right you
get this little bit of information and
then it's done and that's basically and
then it wraps up and it's a cool little
moment here because the question is are
beings actually going to achieve a
higher level of Essentia is this really
the fate of humanity that humans and
mutants are essentially going to be
wiped out and they're going to be
replaced by robot biological being
hybrid this is kind of an important
thing here because if you go back and
you look at Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers and I know I keep saying that
everything from his Fantastic Four all
the way up until now is all one giant
cohesive story right and so when you
look at that you say okay you have the
the portion of the story where Captain
America and Black Widow and Hawkeye and
I think somebody else I can't remember
get flung into the future and along the
way they basically start dropping off
but you get 50 000 years into the future
and you basically end up realizing that
like the Avengers transcend the Earth
and become this Universal Protection
Force right so like there's a future
there but how do you get from point A to
point B and will that Future come to
fruition that's really what's being
presented to us here by Jonathan Hickman
and that's really the question that we
have to ask
okay so we are picking up with House of
X part 5 and this is actually one of the
the coolest things because like a lot of
crazy things happen in this and
everything changes in its entirety right
it's like I just want to kind of Dive
Right into this so what we do here is we
initially pick up with uh Lorna Dane and
with uh Magneto now the cool thing about
this is that remember where Lorna Dane
is exceedingly powerful and she has the
powers of Magneto for all intents and
purposes there is still a lot of
learning that goes on there with her
insofar as the world of Magneto plays
and how cocoa works and all that kind of
cool stuff and so sort of passing this
wisdom on is a bit of a cool thing
because what she what ends up happening
is she asked the question is there any
good to humanity and Magneto responds to
this by saying well there was a point
when Humanity was composed of hunters
and gatherers right it was a nomadic
setup where humans would just travel
from one place to the next they would
basically Forge for food or or resources
or what have you and then move on to the
next it wasn't until Humanity started
settling near bodies of water and then
started forming civilizations around
those bodies of water and then expanding
in a network direction that they
basically created society and in doing
that they of course pass that on to me
in kind not in a literal sense but in
the sense that mutant con could
basically follow the path of humanity
and find a refuge unto itself ideally
the island of krakowa so again like it's
kind of interesting here because what
ends up happening is you basically have
what's What's called the coming together
of the five and it's a really cool
concept because what this means is there
are five mutants that have been brought
here selectively by Charles Xavier
himself and the reason is because they
serve five particular purposes the first
person here is Fabio Medina now Fabio
Medina was a character or is a character
rather who creates these kind of like
Golden Balls which nobody ever really
seemed to care about what you end up
finding out is they were actually eggs
now what Hickman doesn't explain here is
if these eggs are created and if these
eggs are planted somewhere will they
gestate given enough time or are they
simply unfertilized eggs right well they
sort of Wither and die and go away as if
they're never fertilized at all or will
they just sit there for all time waiting
to be fertilized we're not really given
an answer to that question but it's kind
of cool because we don't need one
instead we're basically giving this
scenario to where you have uh you have
Proteus the son of Mora McTaggart who
can again manipulate reality in a local
life space right we've made videos about
him we've talked about him so you'll
find those down in the description but
using the reality warping abilities of
Proteus and then using you know some of
the preserved DNA which we'll talk about
that here in a second as well as using
Elixir who can basically give life what
this does is it allows them to in turn
use the powers of Eva Bell to manipulate
time and then speed up the gestation
process and essentially create New
Mutants now the this is one of the
reasons why reading everything that
Hickman does is exceedingly important
because when you look at this you say
okay well where'd they get the DNA from
we got that last little tidbit from The
Last Comic right where like Charles
Xavier basically asked Mr Sinister to
create a giant repository of mutant DNA
this is why so that at a future point in
time he could start resurrecting X-Men
and that's basically what he does he
recreates all the X-Men who died on the
facility on the satellite during their
initial launch now it may seem kind of
like a hand wavy thing and a way to just
to kind of be like well you know is
whatever you know and and just kind of
like bring a character back from the
dead in a really convenient manner right
I mean some people will look at it that
way Hickman is never that way right this
is designed to introduce a concept this
is designed to introduce a way in which
a mutant can return and do it in a
fashion to where it'll become
exceedingly important later on down the
line right so to a degree it is a bit
hand wavy but this is also one of those
moments where you have to keep this in
the back of your head because if you
don't then you'll basically get lost in
the shuffle and however long it takes
for Hickman to get around to it during
dawn of X but it's kind of a cool little
thing because following that what we
also get is this explanation about about
cerebro and over the year cerebro had
always been billed in Marvel Comics as
this device that was developed through a
combination of Charles Xavier and
Magneto and so on that would allow him
to find any Mutant around the world what
cerebro can actually do is it's
basically been copying the mental
patterns of of X-Men all across the
entirety of its existence right and so
what this does is it allows the DNA as
it was kept by Mr Sinister to resurrect
the physical bodies of the X-Men and
then in turn the information stored in
cerebro allows them to basically
reinstall the the mind so to speak of
the person who is created right now
again this is not Hickman making this up
we saw this happen in the Iron Man
comics you know so we've seen this
happen a multitude of times over the
years of Marvel Comics whereby a
person's mind can be more or less backed
up and when that person dies if they're
recreated their mind can be reinstalled
back into their brain and they'll go
back as they normally would right
they'll go back completely functioning
and so it's kind of a cool thing because
what you get here is the return of all
these X-Men who died right you get the
return of Wolverine you get the return
of Nightcrawler of Jean Gray of Cyclops
all these characters Monet Saint Croix
the whole nine yards all these
characters that died have all basically
been brought back and so it's one of
these cool things because storm
basically goes out there and speaks to
the people of kakoa on behalf of Xavier
Magneto and all them and says like these
people have been recreated and I know
there's some degree of distrust right
you don't know if it's truly them you
know it's a mutant but you don't know if
it's truly them so let me verify and by
kind of going through and testing each
one they all pass and the sense that
Cyclops makes makes reference to I
thought I knew what it meant to be like
a strong leader and then you showed me
that's a reference to when Cyclops
battled storm for leadership of the
X-Men and storm 1 and then Cyclops
basically left so that was back during
the old Chris Claremont and Luis and
Walter Simonson and Bob Layton eras of
Uncanny X-Men and X Factor in turn you
basically end up getting like you know
Jean Gray who's tested you have Monet
Saint Croix who's tested she's kind of
like get your hands off of me each one
of these mutants are individually tested
each one of them are tested in a way to
verify that they are who they claim to
be and it's really it's really a way for
Hickman to tell us this is really them
right it's not just like duplicates or I
guess it is to a degree but they're not
like false it's not a false Cyclops
right it's not a fake Monet Saint Croix
or a fake Jean Gray This is actually
them this is is really and truly them
and so it's kind of a cool thing because
where Xavier would be excited about this
and where he would celebrate this moment
the reality is that they're all
basically hinging on a vote from the
United Nations to decide whether or not
to to see krakowa as an actual Sovereign
Nation right like is it its own Island
like its own country where only mutants
reside now this is an important theme
because this Magneto basically pulling a
bit of History out of Marvel Comics and
the reason why I say that is that if you
go back and you read X-Men Volume 2
issue number 87 that was a story whereby
Magneto basically sees the magnetic
poles of Earth and then basically
blackmailed Humanity into giving mutants
their own Island which of course turned
out to to be genocia and so it's not the
first time something like this has
happened and it's not Hickman just
pulling things out of his backside now
there are vast differences between
genocia and Graco raccoon is a living
Island jenosha was just a giant chunk of
land out there somewhere so again there
are big differences this will be a far
more safe place than genocia ever was
but it is kind of a cool moment here
because what you end up doing is getting
to like the actual day of the vote and
it's kind of a blessing but a curse at
the same time because the votes
ultimately pass you know like like you
basically have uh cocoa going forward as
a nation the issue with this and the way
it worked was that Emma Frost
essentially swayed the vote using her
telepathic powers and Charles Xavier
basically says hey look we appreciate
everything you've done just know things
like this always come at a cost and
while it's it's not really made clear by
Jonathan Hickman what this basically
means is that somewhere along the line
someone's gonna realize people's minds
were tampered with and while the vote
has really just kind of gone through and
there's not much they can do to undo it
I guess they could try to they could try
to vote against it you know and kind of
ban them you know take away their their
their Nation but what that would do if
that were the case is it would lead to a
war between humans and mutants right
because it would basically be Humanity
saying all right all you mutants now
have a place of your own and then saying
never mind no you don't and then taking
it back right so I mean you know here's
a safe haven never mind now you have to
flee for your lives all over again and
it just wouldn't work right and so what
this does with with United with cocoa
now being listed as an actual Sanctuary
a livable sanctuary and Island that's
governed and occupied only by mutants
and the only people that can get in that
are non-mutants are those that mutants
allow to get in basically brings in a
whole host of different people and so
you've got Mr Sinister and his Marauders
you've got benadu Perry which is
actually really cool to see Exodus here
and you have apocalypse and this is one
of the coolest moments here because
apocalypse showing up is just kind of
like wow like this is this is wow
because remember when it comes to
apocalypse outside of what we saw in
that that future conflict where he was
defeated by Nimrod which I still don't
agree with I still think apocalypse
could have defeated Nimrod I feel like
he should have I feel like Nimrod just
not powerful enough to defeat apocalypse
that's me as the fan talking with no
factual evidence to back that up outside
of the powers that apocalypse has but I
feel like apocalypse should have won
that battle but but apocalypse showing
up here is a big thing because we would
expect him to show up and then instigate
conflict you know to test those
individuals who believe that they're
powerful enough when in reality he's
actually showing up here fairly benign
of course yes history with cocoa we
talked about that in the last video and
so he really shows up to this island
more as a friend and when he's speaking
with Magneto and speaking with Wolverine
Magneto says we need to hear you say
that basically you're not going to cause
trouble here because if you are going to
cause trouble then we'll kick you out
right we'll just have cocoa banish you
and it's kind of cool because his
response is no I'm not here to cause
problems you all turn out to be exactly
what I wanted you to be over the years
over my entire existence I've pitted the
weak against the strong in an effort to
eliminate the weak like you guys in this
point right now have become the strong
you've literally moved away from the
point where you're falling prey to this
ideology of well we can help them see
the error of their ways we can if we're
nice enough we can get them to change
their minds right I mean that doesn't
work right I mean if you're nice enough
all you're going to do is get conned and
so like like in this instance it's kind
of like you guys have finally woken up
to the reality of the world that being
nice is just not the way that it works
right like the world's filled with nice
people and none of them are really get
anything done right I mean it's all
those individuals who are willing to do
whatever needs to be done in order to
get things done that end up getting
things done and he's like do you've
woken up to this reality now like you've
woken up to the way things are to the
way the world is you have become what I
always wanted you to be you are now the
strong and so it's a cool thing because
when he finally concedes and says from
this day forward I'm not apocalypse
standing alone I am part of you
basically apocalypse joins the X-Men and
it's the coolest thing ever because what
Xavier says is if that's the case then
welcome home
okay so getting into powers of X part 5
like we are getting to a point where the
series is wrapping up the series is
coming to an end and uh I am very much
excited about this because I'm really
curious to see not even because I'm not
really excited because it's ending I'm
excited because I want to know where it
goes next right I mean I'm kind of sad
it's ending to be honest because like
it's been an amazing Story So Far uh but
what this does is it initially picks up
with Forge now here's the thing here's
the funny thing I feel like only the
most steadfast and staunchest of X-Men
fans would know this but Jonathan
Hickman is not pulling this out of
nowhere and here's the cool thing so
initially Charles Xavier meets with
Forge to basically upgrade cerebro this
is one of the reasons why Hickman riding
is so good is because it ties into
everything right so if you come into
this and you haven't really read the
X-Men or you're not really familiar with
the X-Men the idea is okay cool so
somewhere along the lines like Xavier
asked Fords to basically upgrade cerebro
and like but cerebral was originally
made by Xavier so like Hickman's
changing the past no that's not true um
if you go back and you read X-Men Volume
2 issue number five there's a point
where uh where Xavier approaches Forge
and basically says you're a mutant with
the ability to basically be Tony Stark
more or less right like that's his power
right his power is that he knows he can
basically understand machinery and how
it works and all that kind of cool stuff
that's why like Forge is basically the
X-Men's version of Tony Stark the
difference is that Forge lost if he lost
his powers he'd be no more capable of
understanding Machinery than you know
you or me like complex Machinery then
like you or me right I mean we can't
build an Iron Man suit uh but the fact
remains that that during that second run
of X-Men like X-Men Volume 2 basically
what ended up happening is in the
aftermath of everything that happened
with the Phoenix soccer the dark Phoenix
sagas and all that kind of stuff that
Xavier basically approached Forge and
asked him to upgrade cerebro using shiar
technology and so what this shows is
basically how we got to that point right
like where Xavier basically walks up on
on uh on Forge and says I need you to
show me how it is that you you know like
I need you to upgrade cerebro with Shear
technology and the reason why is
actually a little bit different here so
beforehand it was simply just like the
system needs to be upgraded right like
we need to have a more like we need to
have a better reach and a stronger
understanding of everything but
beforehand it was it was away from Alvin
to basically kind of bring the X-Men
into like the Modern Age of Storytelling
essentially and really kind of upgrading
everything across the board the reason
why it's actually happening here is
because with what what it is that Xavier
wants to do cerebro is simply not
powerful enough but when it comes to the
CR technology that's out there it
definitely is that Xavier essentially
wants to have a system of redundancy
right he wants to have a system to where
he can copy the minds of all the mutants
in existence now we know that from the
last house of x video but the question
was how do we get to that point and how
does it work and how can it last for the
long term and that's what Ford says
Forge is like well what you're asking
here is not something as simple as I
want to copy the minds of all beings in
existence it's a lot more nuanced than
that like one you need to be able to
basically have an unlimited amount of
storage right because what you're
talking about doing is backing up the
minds of an individual person and then
in turn having to back it up on a
regular basis right because what happens
if you back up the mind of someone and
then they turn evil and then they die
but you want to bring them back if the
only version that you have is the most
recent one which was their evil version
you're gonna bring back the evil version
of themselves instead you want to go
back to like back in the day you can
pick which version of themselves that
you want to bring back in this new body
that you would essentially be creating
for them and so if you do that like
you're going to need a vast amount of
storage because you're talking about
mapping and storing the human psyche
which is anybody will tell you it takes
a little bit more than a thumb drive and
then from there you're talking about
having a system of redundancy meaning
that you're gonna have to have multiple
backups so that you you don't have to
worry about if one of them goes down or
gets destroyed that you've lost all your
data so what you're talking about is an
unlimited amount of information stored
on an unlimited amount of storage like
how in the world do you expect to pull
this off nothing on Earth exists like
that and that's when Xavier says yes but
the shiard aren't really like they're
Way Beyond Humanity in terms of
Technology like they can store unlimited
amounts of information and basically
keep their technology going on forever
hence the reason why they're an entire
Galactic spanning Civilization this
conquered multiple civilizations and
forced them all to worship them so it's
basically like I want five backups for
this whole system it's cool and it's
really interesting to see this exchange
between the two because ultimately
Xavier ends up asking like you're the
only real mutant on our side that I can
try us with this like are you going to
be able to make this work are you going
to be able to pull this off and
ultimately of course as we know from
from X-Men history Forge says yes now
here's the important thing to bear in
mind it could be that that Xavier I'm
sorry that the higgling comes back and
changes that that's one thing to always
bear in mind when it comes to what it is
that Hickman's doing just because things
were a certain way doesn't mean they
will be that way now right I mean the
guys basically reworking rebooting the
X-Men for uh for really the the Modern
Age he could change anything at any
point in time so take it with a grain of
salt it's not an absolute an absolute
you know Form and Function and structure
or anything like that now from this
point this is this is why I love Hickman
World building right because imagine
this but on like a much grander scale
and that's basically how Hickman writes
long-form stories right so like three
four five year runs on the X-Men or the
Fantastic Four or the Avengers and New
Avengers that's basically how this works
and so if you recall one of the ways in
which krakowa was able to operate as a
nation as a nation-state and generate
income was by using the various leaves
of gracoa the various plant life that
was there to synthesize drugs it could
do things like like extend human life by
five years or cure all mental mental
illnesses and different things like that
now something else that that's really
intriguing is the way he shines a light
on Xavier here because Xavier basically
travels to the Louvre alongside Magneto
and usually you know uses his telepathic
Powers forces everybody to leave and
then meets with Emma Frost and remember
this is kind of a cool concept because
the way it seems to be going right now
Emma Frost still has dealings with the
hellfire club right so she's kind of on
again off again with the X-Men it's not
where she was during like Grant
Morrison's run where she's like a
full-on member of the X-Men she's kind
of out doing her own thing at the moment
now a lot of this probably comes out of
X-Men versus Inhumans and the fact that
what she'd done had basically been
revealed but Hickman hasn't really tied
into that so there's no reason to
believe that's the absolute case but the
fact remains that what ends up happening
is Xavier basically tells her like
you're aware of the fact that Krakow is
basically creating medicines out there
that can essentially shut down and
really ruin the entire pharmaceutical
industry in the rest of the world like
you're aware that that's what we're
doing right like we're basically pumping
out various medicines and cures that the
pharmaceutical company doesn't really
seem to be interested in doing because
they're putting money they're putting
profits over progression and so because
of that like we've basically stuck
Captain where they failed and we've
essentially dominated the market now and
and we've we've shut off pretty much
every at every access point where
anybody could topple us right like we
own the means of production we keep the
means of production secret no one gets
in or out of kakoa unless they let them
so it's not like Humanity could sin in a
spy it's not at the pharmaceutical
industry could send in a spy and get get
all this information on how to duplicate
these drugs and then in turn send them
out there because even then they would
need krakowa to make them so any drug
they created would be a half measure
Humanity would sniff it out fast they
would turn on it and they would go back
to using the drugs that are coming out
of cocoa the various medicines coming
out of there and so it's like we've
essentially dominated and courted this
corner of this Market in its entirety
what we need is the means to be able to
get into countries that have a mutant
population and countries that have
rejected our offer and this is what so
and so really nefarious about what it is
that Xavier is doing because what he
basically tell her tells Emma Frost is I
need you to get back into contact with
Sebastian Shaw I need you to rejoin the
hellfire club and it's just kind of like
wow because it's like you will be the
front face operation right you'll get 50
like I'm sorry you'll get a 50-year
contract with a a more than fair share
of money that's generated here and then
in turn she'll be the public face she'll
be the marketing phase right she'll be
the one you see on TV and the
commercials and I'm in on Frost you want
to live five more years well then take
this drug from cocoa you know or
different things like that you know what
will really go on is with a black king
with with Sebastian Shaw because of the
fact that he is by all intents and
purposes a criminal he's a bad guy but
he still has a lot of contacts and a lot
of reach due to the fact that the
hellfire club really immersed itself in
what was essentially world domination
albeit behind the scenes that what
Sebastian Shaw can do is get their drugs
into into these countries that have
rejected the offers of krakowa by using
like black book operations and then in
turn get mutants out and get the drugs
in it's a pretty nefarious plan because
what it basically means is flooding
countries with the krakowan drugs and
and it's it's pretty Sinister like it's
pretty dark Xavier is becoming like a
drug kingpin now it's essentially what
it is now it's interesting because
Xavier masks it behind the perception of
well it's all in the effort of getting
mutants out and basically getting them
back home but but it seems it even then
it's pretty dark and this is this is
actually really cool I dig this because
what it shows is that Xavier is willing
to do whatever needs to be done in order
to get his mutants back home right I
mean that's one of the things we've
talked about recently the people who win
the wars are the ones that do what needs
to be done to win the war not the guy
trying to change the hearts and Minds
that doesn't work but it's it's cool it
works really effectively because at the
end of the day Emma Frost basically says
yes I'll side with you on this I'll help
you make this happen we will find a way
to pull this off and that's why it's so
awesome here that's why you see this
this really cool concept because what
they also do is they say we want to
bring you on we want to give you two
seats on the quiet Council of cocoa
basically a council of twelve that's
leading the krakowan uh mutant
population basically the entirety of the
mutant population all going to be led by
by a council of The Twelve Magneto
Professor X of course with it being
named after the after the seasons
Magneto Professor X are going to be you
know two of the three we don't know the
other ones and then we know that
Sebastian Shaw and Emma Frost are going
to take two spots and then Emma Frost is
asking for a third we have no idea who
that one's gonna go to it'd be awesome
if it went to Hellion if they brought
him back back but nonetheless at this
point it basically is it's kind of like
this telepathic message sent out to
Xavier which gives us the reason why all
these mutants appeared on kakoa in the
last issue it's basically saying like we
are working on a thing like krakowa will
become your home if you choose to accept
it if you want to be here you'll be safe
from all prying eyes you'll be safe from
from all forms of Humanity's oppression
this will be a safe space for you notice
here that what what Xavier's basically
doing here is Avalon right Avalon
Providence whatever you want to call it
you know from Magneto's history when he
created like asteroid M and basically
brought all the mutants or his mini
Muses would leave Earth Xavier opposed
him at that point in time it was like
that's a terrible idea we have to have
the peaceful coexistence between between
humans and mutants what Xavier seems to
have recently done and or done in recent
years is understand that like sometimes
you can't change the hearts and minds of
people and you never should have tried
in the first place that what you should
have done was just said hey look if
that's how you want it to be that's fine
then we'll all just go over here but
understand like let me make this clear
and know uncertain terms you stay away
we stay away if you come over to where
we're at then we're gonna we're gonna
bring everything you know and love to
ruin right while everything that you
know and love burns down around you and
Ash you're gonna have to look and accept
the fact you did this to yourself at the
end of the day it's basically keeping
all the mutant populations safeguarded
by whatever means necessary now a funny
thing that kind of goes on here and this
is why I love the way that Jonathan
Hickman writes the name of the
Submariner name of the Submariner gets a
message of course from from Xavier
because Neymar's a mutant and so as a
result of that Neymar of course being a
proud King you know the king of Atlantis
is told by Xavier why in the world would
I accept your offer you want to play
King and that's cute and that's fine but
boy I've been a king for eons like I've
been a king for a long time so while
it's nice that you want to do this you
hardly know what it means so you don't
really understand what you're asking you
don't know what you're creating you're
just doing a thing whereas I understand
what it really means to be a king so if
you want to give me your offer that's
fine but come back when you're serious
come back when you actually mean it and
you actually know what you're talking
about dude I love Neymar I love the way
that Hickman writes Namor because he's
so arrogant and so haughty it's so
awesome just to see Neymar written in
such a such a really cool way but again
jumping 1 000 years in the few future in
the last few issues or so we had
basically talked about how this new
elevated form of what was essentially
kind of a combination of humanity and
Machinery had basically moved in the
direction of wanting to be absorbed by
the failing right it kind of becoming
part of this Universal Consciousness so
basically going out and becoming
something greater you know a higher
state of Enlightenment or entropy or
whatever it is you want to call it it
was a cool thing because with them
reaching this point and the Phalanx
arriving the question was if we
essentially put our Consciousness into a
pure machine shell as opposed to you
know part human and part machine are you
guys going to accept that and the
response of the of the the Phalanx is
now given when they say yes we find this
acceptable we find it acceptable that
that because you were bred is a
combination between whatever your
biological race was which was human and
Machinery being merged together as a
cyborg reaching its current form of
Enlightenment you're not truly a machine
and we as the Phalanx only absorb like
machine based entities so put your
Consciousness in a machine and you can
come hang out like it's basically what
it comes down to and it works because as
soon as that happens the elders
basically eradicated by the by the
entirety or at least by this particular
Phalanx force and when the question is
asked by the librarian when it's talking
to this future version of nimrod why is
it the Elder was destroyed new mod
basically responds by saying when it
comes to the Phalanx there's simply just
but one phase out there and this is
Hickman doing a huge amount of World
building because what Hickman basically
says is that throughout the entirety of
the universe you have black holes and
where conventional wisdom would tell us
that black holes are just giant gravity
Wells right collapsed dead stars could
suck in everything around it including
light and nothing gets in and it just
gets broken down on the atomic level and
then who the hell knows what happens at
the center of it because it's all
theoretical because nobody's ever been
there before what he actually says here
is that these black holes are
essentially collapse dead civilizations
right like entire intellectual
civilizations whose entire overall
knowledge and experience and everything
just collapsed in on itself basically it
got so smart it collapsed in on itself
and when that happened it basically
created a kind of fissure in space time
but each one is not really alone instead
is part of a greater whole and this
greater hole is this giant series of
networks and so essentially every single
black hole in the universe is one part
of this giant Collective consciousness
and so because of that like it's all
networked and the the Phalanx in turn
come under that you know and it's a cool
concept because what it basically means
is that it's it's literally the
universe's own intelligence more or less
it's a cool thing because what this
means is that this kind of higher level
thinking that it starts out that if you
really kind of piece these things
together and this is why Jonathan
Hickman is such an amazing writer if you
piece these things together what you
have are Baseline Sentinels from
Baseline Sentinels you go to mother or
you go to master molds from Master modes
you go to Mother moles from mother molds
you go to like actual like Omega signals
right so basically a blending between
human and machine from there you go on
to a higher level which is the Nimrod
and then from the Nimrod you go on to
yet even higher levels if they get high
enough they achieve like I'm sorry they
achieve a late a state of Enlightenment
they end up getting to their current
form and then from there they merge with
the Phalanx and emerging with the
Phalanx goes on to become even an even
bigger part of an Empire which the
Phoenix themselves serve this absolute
intelligence Across the Universe it's an
awesome sort of introduction right
because you know Hickman really breaks
this down you've got the technoc you've
got the world mind you've got the
falayan you've got Titans you've got
you've got the the stronghold and then
you've got a Dominion right so kind of
going from like the Baseline and then
building it all the way back up here
there are multiple threats right there
are multiple Concepts they really all
kind of seem to lead to this final level
of super intelligence it's a cool
concept I'm digging it
man let me tell y'all something man let
me tell y'all something
man let me tell
you man let me tell you something man
man that's awesome all right look here
look here's the thing folks all right
here's the thing all right here's the
thing House of X is done House of X is
finished and it is legit oh hey by the
way um what is it right now it's it's
around 8 30 a.m uh mountain time so
that's 10 30 a.m uh Standard time or
Eastern Standard Time uh so we'll say at
about 11 30 a.m give or take time for my
my Editor to edit the video for it for
it to go up and for you guys to be able
to watch it we'll say 11 30 a.m uh
Eastern Standard time I will be live on
Twitch twitch.tv I am Rob Jefferson uh
coming out we'll do like a live q a
while I'm playing Destiny 2. it'll be
pretty awesome okay so so here's so
here's the thing right okay so I am
hyped for the conclusion of House of X
like I am I dude this is oh okay
obviously Hickman sets stuff in place
for like dawn of X right and I told
people he was good I told man I'm gonna
chase him I'm reading the X-Men for 25
years folks I know what I'm talking
about I told people this was going to
happen right I told people this exactly
what's going to happen the Jonathan
Hickman is going to plant the seeds for
like dawn of X right it's not just gonna
end it's not gonna be a self-contained
thing it's like it's it's basically like
like dark rain the Fantastic Four right
like if you want to understand Jonathan
Hickman's Fantastic Four run you have to
cover the Fantastic Four dark range
story and maybe we should but like maybe
we should but like if you want to
understand Hickman's run you have to
cover that yeah because like that's the
beginning of it all that's how it all
starts so uh so here's the thing man
like okay so so initially this picks up
down in like the Citadel right because
the big question people have had here is
where is Maura McTaggart right like
where's Maura McTaggart in all of this
stuff that we've seen in House of X
because in all the other alternate
realities all the other lives that she's
lived whatever you want to call them
like she's always been there where is
she at we haven't seen her once this
entire time and there's been all these
theories floating around like I saw
theories in the comments section when
people were saying that Professor Xavier
is actually more a mctider like which is
a cool Theory it's wrong but it's a cool
Theory alright more mctaggard is there
and here's a crazy thing this is really
kind of like this discussion between
between Maura and and Magneto and Xavier
where they basically say if we do this
if we start this process there's no
going back here like if we do this if we
start this process there's no going back
there's there's no unringing this Bell
right like we'll cross the line that we
can't come back from and Xavier's
response is I understand like I get what
it is it's coming so literally here's
it's the coolest thing in the world see
this is why I love Jonathan Hickman
right because Jonathan Hickman is really
really good at doing these scenarios
where like a character who's really
powerful basically got into the world
and just be like you're all screwed like
you are all screwed dude I love this
okay so so here's so you have to
understand the X-Men history right like
the accident have constantly been
persecuted cast off been been
manipulated been been screwed over been
left hanging over and over and over and
over again constantly happening in the
realm of of Marvel college right like
Humanities always stood idly by and
either let them be attacked or actually
gone after themselves right the Friends
of Humanity the right like all these
different groups the purifiers and in
the Marauders of Mr Sinister like even
the superhero Community like the
Avengers and so on even most of them are
just kind of stood by and not really
done anything Cyclops made that point in
Avengers versus X-Men man right you guys
remember that conversation between
Cyclops and and Captain America were and
even talking like Reed Richards is kind
of like you guys have willfully stood by
and let us be persecuted you guys have
willfully stood by and let these groups
come after us and eliminate our kind and
where were you during the events of of
ES4 Extinction were the Avengers to help
rescue US during ES4 Extinction where
were the Avengers during the events
during the story arc of of God loves man
kills where where were you when when we
had the purifiers coming after us when
we had the right coming after us and the
Friends of Humanity coming after us and
factor three coming after us where were
you when all this was going on and so
it's it's so cool because at this point
Humanity's like we've had enough I'm
sorry mutank like we've had enough we're
done so Xavier puts on his helmet right
puts on his helmet and addresses the
world and says World Humanity here's the
deal in the coming in the coming days in
the coming months and in the coming
period of time you will learn that we
here mutants on the island of krakowa
have basically created drugs here that
that are pharmaceutical Fountains of
Youth basically right they they can cure
people of most cancers they can extend
your life by five years they can cure
most mental illnesses now there was a
time when I would have just given you
these drugs because what I wanted was a
peaceful coexistence between humans and
and mutants what I wanted was for us to
be able to bond together now keep in
mind the whole of the superhero
community and all of humanity has
listened to this he's like there is a
time when all I wanted was peace but you
didn't want that the superheroes let us
die time and time again you as Humanity
either came after us or stood by and did
nothing so I'm not giving you anything
I'm not giving you any drugs you're
gonna have to live your life as best you
can if you want them you have to pay for
them and it's just like dude this is
legit because it's Xavier just like
sticking that knife in and just being
like like you could have had the life
you could have had this dream you could
have had things but you could have had
the perfect world but instead you had to
be idiots instead you had to be selfish
you had to be vile and you had to be
cruel and you had to turn your guns on
us despite the fact that we'd really
done nothing wrong and so because that
if you want the these drugs if you want
to be able to have these things then
there are two form of payments that come
into this the first is you have to
accept that cocoa is going to be a
nation state unto itself that we're
basically going to be autonomous that we
do not answer to any existing government
out there aside from the United Nations
we are on par with China and the United
States and all these various Nations
that exist out there that govern
themselves and so long as they don't
violate things like the Geneva
conventions then we're fine the second
is that at Birth the moment they are
born any Mutant out there in the world
can claim krakowa is citizenship which
means if your child grows to be 13 years
old and her mute and his or her mutant
Powers manifest and they're reading
online about how the island of kakoa is
is a nation-state that they can at that
point in time say I want to be a citizen
of cocoa and leave and there's nothing
their parents can do to stop them that
any Mutant anywhere can make that claim
and they are now protected under the
laws of krakowa that the laws of man no
longer no longer affect mutants it's a
crazy thing like if you want to do if
you want these drugs if you want to be
able to improve your life you have to be
able like you you have to do this now
here's the thing is this kind of reading
between the lines is because it's sort
of like and if you decide to make a move
against us all hell's gonna break loose
it's one of the coolest things you know
he's like from this day forward mutant
kind is governed by mutant laws not
Mankind's laws these are not negotiable
terms there's no sitting down at a table
and getting us to basically finagle and
change our minds or anything like that
like this is basically how this is going
to be we're asking you for a better life
and in return we will give you the same
like that's basically how this is going
to work and it's so it's it's so like
this is the best this is the best part
right this is the best part right here
he basically says if you if you find
yourself in a position asking the
question who are we as mutants to make
terms like this we're the future right
like for for countless eons you as human
beings have gone to bed and woke and
woke up believing the world would be the
same believing the world would be as it
always was that's not true we are as
true inheritive we are the next step in
human evolution so here's the reality of
the world that you live in while you
slept the world changed and it's just
like dude like it's one of the coolest
things Xavier's like Xavier's not
pulling any punches man it's crazy he
really feels like Magneto here it's like
dude this is this is awesome man like
this is legit here's the other thing too
we end up getting like the quiet counsel
of kakua like the full on Council uh of
the 12 basically albeit we're missing a
single person like a red King right so
we get Professor X Magneto and
apocalypse this is gonna be the coolest
thing because here's a hit like man let
me tell you something dude apocalypse
man dude apocalypse like once you get to
the end of the story like the end of
this issue apocalypse dude it's just
kind of like okay okay apocalypse I see
you man like I do I see what's going on
like it is it's it's legit then you get
Mr Sinister you get Exodus and you get
Mystique right now Mr Sinister is pretty
self-explanatory we have a video
explaining him we don't have a video
explaining Exodus basically Exodus is a
super powerful telepath and telekinetic
right like he's way up there in terms of
his powers uh it's it's nuts what all he
can do but he like Mr Sinister was
created by the villain apocalypse and of
course Mystique speaks for itself you
got Sebastian Shawn Emma Frost which I
love those choices because Sebastian
Shaw is basically a guy who just turns
any kind of in any kind of energy or or
attack this made against them into like
physical strength not to mention he's
got all kinds of fingers and different
pies you know that he's been involved in
over the years and really has a lot of
influence and pools throughout the world
Emma Frost is the exact same way uh
storm Jean Gray and Nightcrawler this is
a cool choice because this is like the
original X-Men basically and or at least
not the original but like the giant size
X-Men more or less was a great callback
to that and then of course you've got
Cipher who speaks for kakoa and gracoa
being the island they all they all
basically reside on now this actually
goes directly into the first meeting of
the council the first meeting of the
12th and it's one of the coolest things
because as this all basically begins to
go into discussion what they end up
doing is bringing out their first
prisoner their first act as a council
which is an action of judgment and what
they the person they end up bringing out
is Sabretooth now remember Sabretooth
was the one who was sent on a mission by
by uh Xavier and all them into the into
the world and then basically he kind of
you know went forward with his own
agenda and once he was caught up to
about mystique and all them they brought
him back right we saw that earlier in
the house of X storyline and so it's
it's crazy because what you end up
basically getting is kind of this debate
that begins to run on between all these
different guys this kind of discussion
that takes place and the question is if
we are a if we are a nation that
believes that is wrong for Humanity to
take our lives then we have to in turn
believe the opposite that is wrong for
he meant for us to take the lives of
humans now in reality this is more of a
safeguarding thing right if Humanity
begins to come to the belief that kakoa
is really nothing more than a warring
nation state it's one of these places
where mutants are gathering forces so
they can eventually launch attack
against humanity and there's credible
reason to believe that well then humans
will strike first it's just the way that
it is but if they kind of uphold this
rule that we are a nation that basically
we don't attack humans and humans don't
attack us they stay away and we stay
away it creates an uneasy Alliance it
still works and it still serves its
purpose but it's one of those things
where it's kind of like we can't
basically decide like we can't be the
judge durian executioner for a group of
people out there who don't follow our
laws but at the same time can we are we
going to be the kind of people who
execute our own mutants like is that the
world that we're gonna play because if
we're if we create this place to
safeguard the mutant population and then
start executing them for crimes that
they commit is that okay and so
basically what they end up doing it's
kind of sitting down and creating these
kind of laws of krakowa basically these
laws that they're all going to follow
these laws that they're all going to
obey and so where you end up having this
this sort of discussion taking place in
Sabertooth Washington unfold Sabertooth
begins to begins to come to the the
realization of the belief that the
entire Council begins to kill him from
there it starts getting into a
discussion of like what's really home
here right I mean like from from Storm's
perspective and the way she makes the
argument home really is a matter of
possession right you know if you possess
your home you own your home therefore
you live inside your home but because of
the fact that cocoa is inherently a
mutant and krakowa is providing them
with a with a dwelling of place to live
has actually Cipher who kind of makes
that argument on behalf of capella that
technically it would be ownership of a
mutant and so because of that it kind of
begins to beg the question if cocoa is
going to allow them a place to live a
place of residency of sorts then can
they truly in turn call it something
that they own and if they do can they
treat it like something that they own
that is to say just treat it however
they want to and the answer to that
question is no that's not the case and
so by virtue of all these discussions
that are going on what they do is create
Three Laws the three laws of krakowa
make more mutants which is to say grow
their ranks because right now our
numbers are severely limited so
somewhere along the line humanity is
going to make an attack humanity is
going to strike and when they do we need
to have a mutant population large enough
to be able to withstand such an attack
the second thing is murder no man do not
murder Humanity uh unless they put us in
a situation where we have to right so
defending our land is Just Cause to
murder a human murdering them
willy-nilly like Sabertooth did that's
not okay and then third respect the
sacred land respect the land of krakowa
these are very three basic and
fundamental but exceedingly important
laws because it's really one of these
things where by the grace of krakowa
goes the mutant population right they
serve at the pleasure of cocoa at any
point in time he could just kick them
all out or just sink himself and they
would have nowhere to live whatever the
case is any number of things could
happen he could turn on them and there's
there's a whole bunch of things that can
take place so it respects the land of
krakowa respect the house in which we're
being given residence that's basically
how this whole thing goes down so then
they start asking the question if the
law if one of the Sacred laws is we we
cannot kill any man outside of defense
that is to say you're basically trying
to get away and there's no way for us to
get away meaning they Corner us or
something like that or they attack our
sacred land then like what do we do with
Sabertooth and the response is well we
can't just kill him instead we are going
to Exile him and so what they do is it's
really really cool here because the
initial response would be if we're going
to Exile him just send him out into
space I'm sorry to send him out into the
world the problem with this is that if
they did that one they'd be basically
like sending him to Suicide somebody
somewhere would try to kill him and two
while that probably wouldn't work what
he could do is dump all his knowledge
about gracoa and the goings-on in mutant
Society out into the highest bidder give
it to the government different things
like that and literally become the the
means by which the entire island of
Krakow would just come crashing down
around them literally just become the
lunch pan that pulls that that gets
pulled out and the whole thing comes
crashing down and so what they end up
doing is exiling him deep down inside of
cocoa itself they literally lock him
away down inside of inside of this this
living Island and so it's kind of nuts
because from there they basically like
celebrate their safe haven they
celebrate at the place they're in now
right it's just kind of like okay let us
go forward from here and mutants like
all these mutants who arrived here and
mutants were arriving every single day
all these mutants who are showing up
here are celebrating this newfound
Freedom that they have and it's
interesting that Hickman's building it
up because he's building it up in such a
way to where they're celebrating Freedom
they're celebrating living in a place
where they don't have to worry about
being persecuted by humanity and where
you have like Xavier and and Magneto who
are who are talking with one another and
who are basically sort of enjoying this
moment and saying look at this world
that we've created what you've got is
apocalypse watching it all go down and
here is my question here's my question
Rob core here's Matt here's what I want
here's what I want to know because I
feel like I feel like things are about
to pop off here's what I want to know
yes apocalypse is on the council yes
apocalypse is there to observe but as
apocalypse is he is he going to step in
when the time comes when Humanity shows
up on the doorstep of krakowa and just
starts unleashing all kinds of craziness
is apocalypse going to act or will
apocalypse stand down and simply just
say whoever survives this whole thing is
worthy like they're worthy of continued
existing like those are those mutants
who were there if you cannot survive and
protect your own land you were never
worthy of living in the first place
right his philosophy of Social Darwinism
that's what I want to know or is
apocalypse does he have more nefarious
plans it is legit I love this story
all right people we are here and let me
no let me tell y'all something man let
me tell man let me tell you something
all right let me understanding I'm
standing up in my recording space right
now I'm not even next to the microphone
man like the soundproofed room I'm
standing in here and I've got the chair
in my hand and let me tell y'all
something man man let me tell you
something man we are man we are here we
are here at the conclusion of powers of
X let me tell you awesome this is uh man
let me tell you awesome
this is why I love Jonathan Hickman man
is because you're like like you read
Jonathan Hickman man
you read Jonathan Hickman's stories and
it's like man I have it all figured out
and I know what's going on and then he's
like no you don't either like it's it's
if God was riding the X-Men right now
this is what it would look like right
now it it's it's it's amazing okay so so
this picks up
God I'm so excited to cover this this
picks up uh initially the exact same way
powers of X number one picked up and
this is awesome I I love the way that
Hickman does this because it's one of
the things I love the most about
Jonathan Hickman right like everything
kind of wraps around and that's why like
house and powers of X is for the most
part self-contained but at the same time
it also continues on especially with the
way everything popped off right so this
starts off basically like back in the
day right like X-Men year zero is really
what what Jonathan Hickman calls it uh
and it picks up with more McTaggart
basically meeting with Charles Xavier
now a lot of what you saw in powers of X
number one is the exact same here right
like House of powers of X number one is
pretty much the exact same and so far as
like more McTaggart sits down she
basically greets Charles Xavier somebody
that he that she knows Xavier doesn't
know who she is and then she's just kind
of like well read my mind and find out
what's going on and so what we do is we
jump to the year of X-Men win drops a
year 1000 with the X-Men now this was
the point in the story and in Hickman's
writing we had Ascension right this idea
that somewhere along the line from what
Hickman was was kind of showing us what
seemed to be going on is that you had
Mana machine which basically merged
right the idea of Nano San that
initially you had signals created by man
and then Sentinels created nimrods and
then in turn they started eventually
creating uh Nanobots right they could
basically attach themselves to humans
and then convert humans into Sentinels
which really came out of like Bastion
right when when uh Nimrod when a single
Nimrod machine merged with a master mode
now that was back in the 90s that was
long before Hickman showed up but he
kind of took that concept of them threw
it in there so it's like okay cool you
know I get what's going on here and then
as a result of that essentially like
humanity and robots whatever it was they
basically cheated a level of Ascension
what we're getting here is nothing like
what we thought it was and I was like
dude this is amazing like this is this
is awesome because once you have the
librarian right this this guy that we'd
seen in the previous in the previous
videos when the librarian enters Into
The Preserve right this kind of like
giant makeshift cage more or less with
animals and different things like that
of course none of it's real and he's
immediately attacked by one of his
inhabitants and he basically says like
how many times are you going to do this
like you're a primitive Beast right like
by the time you realize what you wanted
to do I had already prepared
countermeasures right my mind is far
beyond yours like you just relentlessly
attacking makes you look like a buffoon
and this is when we find out the person
the librarian I'm talking to is
Wolverine he's been alive for a thousand
years and it's like dude and he hasn't
really aged that much right now this is
an accurate depiction of of Wolverine
but like how we saw Wolverine appear in
Old Man Logan it was probably stress
technically speaking Wolverine should
not look like he aged that much in the
span of 50 years it's also kind of an
interesting thing here because one of
the things that Hickman kind of silently
did when it came to house and powers of
X is that when he resurrected Wolverine
and you guys caught on to this like that
you caught on to it faster than I did
but when house and powers of X-Men when
Wolfram was resurrected the implications
seemed to be he didn't have adamantium
in his bones right he didn't have
adamantium bonded to himself he just
came back in his most pure form with
bone claws but like this conversation
between the two is is really really
interesting because what Wolfram says is
that like these individuals here like
basically these mutants inside this
preserve they want to be free like they
want freedom and the responsive
Librarian Is these mutants don't know
what freedom is because for the most
part aside from you and the other they
were born inside this cage this is the
only World they know so how could they
possibly understand the notion of
Freedom if they don't know their
occasion in the first place and the
response will reign is because I've been
telling them because I've been teaching
them about Revolution and I've been
telling them about the world outside
this cage and they want something better
they want something more right and under
normal circumstances if Wolverine hadn't
been there this would have been their
world and so it's kind of a crazy thing
because what the librarian says is I
wasn't waiting on you I was waiting on
her only for them to be met with the
arrival of Maura McTaggart more
McTaggart has apparently been alive all
this time like she's been in this future
this entire time and we don't know what
she's been doing we simply just know
that she's been there and it's kind of
the crazy thing because what we get is
this full-on explanation of what's going
on right I mean the librarian basically
tells them the Phalanx are here we're
going to merge our Essences with the
Phalanx and they're in turn gonna enter
a black hole and our entire Collective
Consciousness is going to be dumped into
one of those big black hole super Gods
whatever it is and that's going to be it
right I mean it's kind of like a higher
state of entropy more or less their
physical forms will vanish and that will
basically be it and it kind of comes as
a shock you know a little bit too to
both more McTaggart and to Wolverine
right like the world is going to end it
kind of comes as a shock to them and
it's interesting here because what it
does what the librarian does is based
basically answer almost all the
questions that we've had that when the
librarian looks at mutants it says like
you're a primitive life form right like
how funny it is that you thought you
were going to be the next step in human
evolution and for the most part they
they are right if they're naturally
occurring that's so that's what the the
librarian says mutants are a naturally
occurring phenomena therefore they're
kind of like Nature's response to the
evolutionary change but at the end of
the day it's all rooted in the notion
that like at any point nature could have
snuffed it up right I mean that was kind
of the whole idea when the celestials
modified the genes of early man and they
planted in place an idea that these
genes would manifest at a single point
in time nature could have rejected it
that was the Grand experiment of the
celestials will nature go alongside it
will nature reject it will it basically
start exercising these genes out of the
various humans that are procreating or
they'll just never activate but because
of the fact that they're the next stage
in human evolution mutants always sort
of Saw themselves this way what the
librarian says is that's not true the
librarian is indeed human that he's an
evolved human it's really kind of how
they progress and it's sort of funny
because in the face of all this we were
kind of like okay so basically humans
and machines merge into like singular
entities and basically humans were more
less wiped out and so were so were
mutants for the most part I mean what's
left of the mutant population is living
in a preserve somewhere that's what the
indications seem to be what we're being
told here is that in response to the
mutant threat and the the increase in
the mutant population the humanity in an
act of desperation basically started
modifying the genes of other humans the
idea was that humans and machines simply
merged together and then ultimately
started creating Supermen and that's
that's really the response here is of
what concerned we're means to humans
when humans could basically start using
biological engineering and create
superhumans of their own and so as a
result of that it seems as though a war
more or less broke out between humans
and mutants and ultimately humans won
and so it's kind of a crazy thing
because like you see this and it's just
like wow like we lost the entire time
more may Target like they didn't know
that and so one of the cool things that
come out of this is that you actually
end up learning that like Wolverine does
have adamantium bonded to his bones
right so like he's returned with
adamantium now we're not really given an
explanation here where somebody just
totally has adamantium in his bones and
so in response to this the librarian
does not initially want to kill Maura
McTaggart and the reason why is because
and you know taking them into whatever
this conscious state is going to be and
then keeping them there for all eternity
it would mean that Maura McTaggart would
never truly die and because she would
never truly die she would never be
reborn as her past self and then be able
to stop this future from happening and
so it's kind of funny here because the
librarian ultimately leaves and then
Wolverine does what he does best and
more mctagger basically says kill me so
I can go back I can be reborn and we can
stop this future from happening
Wolverine kills more McTaggart and thus
ends the sixth life of Maura McTaggart
and I was like dude this was her sixth
life and it's dude it's crazy like it's
it's nuts because it's like okay
everybody's been wanting to know what
the sixth life of Maura mctaggard is
like some of you guys had theories that
like it was Inferno somehow she was
involved in the events of Inferno maybe
like the one who kind of prompted and
pushed uh Madeline prior to just kind of
go crazy and make a deal with demons
like whatever the case is like there
were all kinds of theories right that
like more McTaggart like the the person
running the show is not Charles Xavier
that is actually more mikhetter like
everybody had theories on this and it
was so cool and I think that like
everyone was wrong
I haven't seen all the theories so I
don't know but it's kind of crazy
because with this information kind of
jumping back to the moment when Xavier
was reading the mind of Warren mchaggard
with this information which Halls Xavier
learns is the X-Men always lose in every
single Circumstance the X-Men always
lose in these dystopian Futures it
always plays out the same way and it's
the coolest thing ever right because
this has all really been spearheaded by
the events of like Days of Future Past
that story that Marvel created back in
the day set the stage for like dystopian
Futures and and you know regarding the
mutant population and even the
Superhuman population as a whole in
terms of humanity versus Mutants and
ever since then it's always been this
kind of notion that like it seems that
mutants always lose and all the lives
that more mctaggart's lived and all the
experiences that she's had whether she's
been on the side of Apocalypse who wages
war against what was left of humanity
and the evolved humans and whatnot
fought against Nimrod and all that kind
of stuff and every single one of these
lives mutants always end up losing right
they always end up perishing and that's
kind of the funny thing is because in
response to this Xavier is like well
there's still a chance for us to come
out on top there's still a chance for us
to win here and it's one of the funny
things because you get these sort of
journal entries from Warren mctagon
right we're not going to cover them all
but we get these kind of journal entries
from Maury McTaggart and what she does
is she starts going through and
basically highlighting a lot of the
things that we've already seen but doing
it from her perspective right so like
they've recruited Magneto Magneto can be
a lot more ruthless than Charles Xavier
camp but she also is really kind of
having this discussion of like this kind
of revelation of the truth to Charles
Xavier eventually the time will come
when he will have to walk away from this
idealized perspective of the world right
you have to walk away from the notion of
how he wants the world to be and focus
on the way the world actually is right
like stepping into reality and so it's a
cool thing because what it does is it
sort of highlights this idea that
between the time that more make Hagrid
first encountered Xavier or at least
visited him at the beginning of this
story and at the beginning of house and
powers of X up until now in the modern
day there's been a gradual progression
where Xavier has kind of become a little
more extreme right kind of walked away
from this idea that we can find a
peaceful coexistence between humans and
mutants and instead has basically come
to the realization humans can't be fixed
there cannot be any kind of peaceful
coexistence because in every single
attempt create one it inevitably fails
right because Humanity gets scared they
ultimately create like arms and Armament
they go through whatever steps they need
to even artificially engineering and
improving on themselves in order to
destroy the mutant threat it always
plays out that way it's essentially one
of these things where Xavier sort of
comes to a realization that Magneto's
known his entire life that Humanity
cannot and should not be trusted and you
have to move forward accordingly and so
it's really crazy here because following
this what you end up doing is you end up
having Xavier and Magneto who sit down
with more mchagger and say Here's where
everything stands right now right I mean
the things that we've basically seen so
far the quiet Council has been formed
which is to say the governing body of
the mutant population and more make
Haggard really seems to look at it from
the perspective of the work isn't done
yet but the reality of of where Magneto
and Xavier are coming from is that's
true but you have to relish the small
successes here like with your work and
our our really kind of going forward and
despite the fact that we did things we
weren't supposed to do like getting Mr
Sinister on board things like that what
we've done is create a safe space for
the mutant population we've created kind
of a government unto ourselves that
humans don't need to come to that they
really should not and cannot come to
we've engineered our own method of
infrastructure in terms of economic
growth in terms of social policies in
the form of government we've basically
created our own island nation now the
funny thing about this is like the same
thing was done with genocia right A Safe
Haven Magneto literally held the world
hostage in order to get jenosha and
ultimately he did and then it took one
mutant like it took it took a it took
Cassandra Nova showing up with wild
Sentinels and like that in the blink of
an eye 16 million of them were gone
right so all it takes is one person one
thing to essentially find the in
the armor to bring the whole thing
crashing down and so it's really really
cool there in terms of the possibilities
that can come out of this but at the
moment the mutant population doesn't
care the mutant population is
celebrating everything that's going on
they're enjoying this moment and so it's
kind of a funny thing is because what
they talk about is they had to make
concessions right they had to make deals
that they otherwise wouldn't have made
one of them was with mystique and this
is one of the coolest things in order to
get Mystique onto the quiet Council
Charles Xavier and Magneto had to agree
to bring Destiny back and that's a huge
thing right like Destiny do Destiny's
Diaries I really hope we get Destiny's
Diaries back oh my God that'd be so cool
Destiny's Diaries were a plot device in
Marvel Comics that was basically kind of
involved a series of stories where
Destiny had written down these uh these
like like these possible Futures these
possible outcomes and it was kind of
like this Mad Dash to stop them from
happening it was a really cool concept
that Marvel never really did anything
with after it was all said and done
largely because Destiny was dead and
even the Diaries came out after Destiny
was dead you know after after she was
killed off but Destiny is a mutant who
can see the future she's a pre-cock it's
not an absolute thing but it's still a
relatively strong thing and more Mick
Haggart is kind of terrified of this
right because she's like look if Destiny
is brought back then she'll tell
everybody the fact that like we always
end up losing and so what it seems like
is the entirety of The Quiet Council and
the entirety of the mutant island of
krakowa is really built on Deception
it's built on this idea that all these
mutants were told this will be your safe
haven this will be a place where you can
reside and not have to worry about the
threat of humanity but what seems to
have happened here is that gracoa always
plays out the same way krakowa is
established by the mutant population
that is used by the mutant population as
its own nation and then somewhere along
the line by whatever manner and whatever
means which changes based on the life of
Maura McTaggart War breaks out between
humans and mutants and mutants are
eradicated right so curcuma is a safe
haven only insofar that humans have not
attacked it yet but ultimately they will
always end up losing and none of the
mutants occur KOA know this this is so
deceptive it's not like Charles Xavier
to do this right that's why like this
new version of Charles Xavier is amazing
I love the idea of Charles Xavier
becoming a new version of himself right
it's awesome because I'm tired of the
same old thing I'd like to Charles
Xavier after House of him when he was
basically a dick and like he was cast
out of his own X-Men team and the whole
thing was led by Cyclops dude like the
X-Men after a House of M was amazing
it's cool to see that like the X-Men are
finally getting their due diligence
right it's cool to see that the X-Men
are finally getting like back to
prominence man because then we get dawn
of X and Dawn of X okay check this out
it's like you get you get dawn of X like
the actual launch like the relaunch of
the whole new X-Men thing we get X-Men
number one or we get an X-Men title we
get a Marauders title which I am so
hyped about because Marauders are the
henchmen of of Mr Sinister and I've been
a fan of them for a long long time we
get the return of Excalibur which yeah I
guess is kind of cool we get X-Force uh
we get New Mutants which um yeah that's
it'll be cool we'll see how it goes and
we get fallen angels I don't even know
what in the hell that's about but I'm
curious to find out I haven't looked at
any of the solicitations because I don't
want to spoil anything for myself but
I'm hyped like I am very very excited
news
25 years reading X-Men man I'm so hyped
man it's huh man
I'm sorry I'm so excited people
okay so it all starts here and I'm
really excited to see to see what
Jonathan Hickman does with this this is
X-Men Volume 5 issue number one also
known as dawn of X and I am very excited
about this for those of you guys who are
a little confused about this here's
here's an important thing to understand
volumes and comic books are a weird
thing right like technically volume
denotes an entire run but it's like
volumes within a volume right so you
have like the overarching volume which
is this is however many iterations of
this comic we've had technically we've
had five iterations or five relaunches
of the X-Men comic the first one was
Stanley and Jack Kirby that was the
original X-Men run that was canceled the
second one was X-Men volume Vol 2 issue
number one which came in 1991 and then
there were a whole bunch of others after
that and we're currently on five you had
like all new all different Marvel you
had the post Heroes Reborn you had the
uh the Post House of M the heroic age
you had like all kinds of different
relaunches over the years in Marvel
that's why this is volume Five within
Volume 5 you'll have the first however
many issues make up the first story arc
which will be like volume one so it'll
be X-Men volume Five volume one I know
it's kind of weird uh it's a little
strange but nonetheless this picks up
with an attack on Orcas see this is why
I say you have to read Jonathan Hickman
from beginning to the end right because
Hickman is not gonna he's not gonna do
House of X and then powers of X and then
treat dawn of X like it's a whole new
relaunch now the relaunch came with a
Prelude right so you just kind of keep
on reading as if everything's just kind
of always been but the attack on Orcas
is actually kind of interesting here
because it's not the X-Men launching an
attack in the traditional sense like oh
my God there's humans here we have to
get them it's the X-Men launching like a
really more of like a rescue a rescue
mission than anything else but I really
like the way that Hickman is doing this
right because he depicts the X-Men as
we're going in there to achieve a
mission that's what the counselor calls
for whatever happens happens I like the
Brazen nature of the X-Men now right
because up until this point and this is
one of the things that I wasn't a huge
fan of up until this point really coming
after all new all different Marvel the
X-Men always kind of seemed like a team
that was on the defensive right like
we've like they're always backing off
they're always you know retreating or
something along those lines they're
never really like launching an attack
against someone like making the first
move and I like this you know the X-Men
are kind of going in and they're doing
their thing it's very much a throwback
to the old school Comics I know I sound
like a comic book hipster but I do kind
of I do kind of like the throwback to
the whole thing of course now the
mission is led by storm and cyclops and
this is no accident when it comes to
this like when Hickman really put
together the council and you have
stormings in Cyclops leading field
missions Hickman choses for a reason
right because there's a lot of history
here uh storm and cyclops are kind of
like the one-two punch when it comes to
Leading the X-Men team right Cyclops was
a field commander for a long long time
until after the events of the Phoenix
and dark Phoenix sagas when he left and
then storm became the new leader of the
team after she battled Cyclops for that
role and she won and so as a result of
that storm led the led the X-Men team
while Cyclops LED X Factor and then once
the two teams merged back into a single
unit again you got X-Men gold and X-Men
blue Cyclops LED one team storm led the
other so it makes sense that like
Hickman's sort of bringing all that
history in and giving us these two
characters who are going out and uh and
and doing their own thing the other big
thing about this is the arrival of
Magneto now here's the thing man Hickman
does an amazing job of writing villains
I think Hickman writes villains better
than he writes Heroes if like believe it
or not go back can look at his
publishing history and it's like the
villains are almost always written
better than the heroes and that's what I
love about the way that that Magneto has
done here because in the last five years
or so Magneto's almost kind of been like
a background character Cyclops sort of
took on the role that used to belong to
Magneto by the way it's kind of
militaristic we'll do whatever we need
to do to win kind of situation and it
was cool to see the evolution of his
character to see him go for like the
X-Men Boy Scout to Casting Xavier out of
his own team after House of M kicking
the X-Men over saying I'm the one
running the show now falling more in
line with Magneto's views but then you
know kind of fell more to the to the
background and to see Magneto kind of
brought to the Forefront again and
really kind of drawn and depicted in
this way where he's like this imposing
figure like crap Magneto's here like I
like seeing that like I like I love
seeing that depiction because it's just
like you're talking about this insanely
powerful mutant right I think in a lot
of ways people sleep on just how
powerful Magneto is and I feel like
before this all really comes to an end
before Hickman's run ends we're gonna
see Magneto shine in spectacular fashion
to say nothing of that suit Magneto
looks like a boss in that white silver
suit dude it looks legit it but
nonetheless you know it's it's cool to
kind of see him arrive here because
Polaris like let's take care of these
humans and it's like no no we're here
for a mission we're here to achieve a
mission for the council now this is a
big deal and this is a very important
thing to take note of because what this
shows is that at the end of the day
Magneto really does fall in line with
the ideology that they're ensuing right
because one of the things he says here
is like there was a time when I would
have just taken all these humans out
right like I would have just eradicated
them all and it's not a matter of
annihilating humanity it's a matter of
achieving that goal right there and
that's one of the big differences back
in the day back in like the 80s and 90s
Magneto would have just taken him out
and that would have been even that right
he would have just melted these guys and
they were you know just kind of
destroyed them and that would have been
the end of them but to see him in a
position now where he's just sort of
like we're here to achieve a particular
goal it's awesome to kind of see that
progression but with them showing up
here with the X-Men arriving here that's
what we end up realizing the reason why
they're here is because what they're
doing is rescuing all these various
mutants but one of these mutants stands
out and when the system more or less
opens up right this this kind of you
know cocoon stasis pod whatever it is
opens up and this mutant pours out then
the initial analysis is well they're
they're not really human but they're not
really Newton they're kind of post-human
but something's going on here with
regards to time now if you're not
familiar with Hickman writing if you're
not familiar with the stuff he's done in
the past you would just kind of be like
what in the world is going on here but
if you read the Ultimate Universe if you
read ultimates by Jonathan Hickman
that's a child of the Vault and it's
just like wow dude I can't believe he
brought him back like I can't believe he
brought he's bringing back Children of
the vault at least that's what it looks
like the only other thing I can assume
here is that it's The Black Vault or
something else going on there but I
don't think it's Black Vault like
literally they say like like some kind
of like temporal like temporal energy is
coming off this girl now those of you
guys who don't know Children of the
Vault dude it was so cool this was a
concept I've got the videos down in the
description so you guys can go watch
those but the children of the Vault was
this concept created by by Reed Richards
in the Ultimate Universe and what he did
was create this place called City this
great big huge Citadel and what ended up
happening here is that within the
confines of City time passed differently
and so what Reid could do is he could
basically create life and then watch it
grow over the course of however long and
it was something like 6 000 years past
within the span of like a few days or
something along those lines but
basically he created like post-humans
right people who evolve Beyond normal
humans and this this is awesome because
what it means is the plot thickens
because now not only do we have to deal
with Omega Sentinels we have all the
stuff that we saw with regards to like
the nimrods and all those things going
on and how some powers of X now we've
got post humans making their return and
this is awesome because most humans are
basically superhumans it's awesome to
see Hickman bring it back the downside
to this is this child of the Vault
immediately teleports out she's just
like I gotta go like we got to bounce
out of here keep that in the back of
your head do not forget that that will
become important later on
I promise you that will become insanely
important later on do not forget that
please for the love of God do not forget
that it will become important later on
but nonetheless once they get back to
krakowa it's kind of interesting there
because storm is more or less been
running on fumes since she's been here
grabbing these mutants that were held
inside the Hub and bringing them back to
this location it's fine for what it is
right because it's kind of like hey
they're gonna get some medical treatment
and then they're all going to be okay
everything's gonna be fine remember
kakoa is a totally self-contained
ecosystem right so if they've got
telepaths to deal with like any sort of
mental anguish they've been through
kokoa itself creates various medicines
and things they can use in order to heal
themselves or you know recover from from
whatever they're struggling from but
then following that you've also got the
return of Magneto now notice this when
Magneto arrives here he's almost
perceived as like a savior of sorts and
this is really Hickman tying into the
history of Magneto right like on the
surface you would look at it and say
well Magneto dude this guy's a jerk man
he's a glory hog like just everyone I
freed you all me alone by myself I did
it and it's like okay Magneto get a
little carried away with yourself no no
Magneto has always been viewed in a lot
of ways by the mutant population as kind
of a mutant messiah-esque character not
insofar as they would follow him into
Oblivion right I mean he doesn't always
have everybody on his side but the
perception of Magneto and the way in
which he he operates is he's not really
a bad guy Magneto was a guy who was just
kind of like I'm doing what's best for
mutant kind I'll take the heavy-handed
approach if I need to right but like
first and Forefront is a mutant
population he's a champion of mutes
right and where Xavier was more of a
half measure more of like well let's see
if we can't talk to them let's see if we
can't reason with them you know if we
can get him to listen like Magneto was
like no you can't either so like either
they can listen or they can be made to
listen but ears are going to be listened
to what it is we have to say it's the
nature of things right like violence is
not always the answer but it is a answer
and it's a very effective answer right
Magneto got stuff done and and it's it's
a cool thing about his character and so
him showing up here people are kind of
like well what if they come back and the
response to Magneto is the most boss
response ever he says let man run from
me dude Magneto is a boss
I love the way he's written in this is
absolutely amazing but it's a cool thing
here because what you end up doing is
you end up having Scott Summers who
basically travels uh travels out to meet
up with the rest of his family but
before we do we've got Jonathan Hickman
establishing uh in a lot of ways the
current status quo of things which is to
say the new villain who's on the scene
and this is a guy named director davo
now director davo is the one who really
sort of spearheaded this whole orcus uh
orcis system right at least that seems
to be the case he's the one that
gathered together all these various
scientists from like shield and armor
and and Hammer and Hydra and so on and
so forth all for the purpose of trying
to find a way to basically contain and
control the mutant threat right so it's
almost like a reworked version of
project wide awake for those of you guys
who never read Comics back in like the
back in the 80s and 90s which
technically I wasn't really alive at
that point but I went back and read them
anyway for those of you guys who weren't
really reading when the events of the
original project Wide Awake were
happening it wasn't really like a one
shot it was just like like a page here
three or four pages there you know it
was just kind of spread all over the
place and when you go back and you read
it you read like the entirety of Chris
claremont's run you get this great big
huge cohesive concept that we call
project wide awake this was very similar
to that in terms of how this is being
done and how it's being depicted you get
a couple Pages here and then you move on
right that's that's kind of how this
whole thing this whole thing sort of
unfolded in the old Claremont stories
and it's cool to see that method of
Storytelling kind be kind of being
maintained here but the idea is that
this guy director davo is the one who's
basically like hey look this is the
entire like creation of of mother mold
all that kind of stuff that's all me and
it's one of these things where he sort
of ignores what it is that kareema is
telling him right remember Karima is an
Omega Sentinel she's basically more
machine than she is human but the idea
behind this is she's like what you were
doing was going to spark a response you
had to know that you had to know that
like creating a sentinel that created
that created Master molds which in turn
would create other Sentinels you had to
know the X-Men were going to respond to
that you instigated a scenario where the
X-Men were guaranteed to respond and
when they did they ended up killing a
handful of people who worked for you and
the response of director davo is yes but
that's the step that needs to be taken
I'm doing the right thing I'm fighting
on beside on behalf of humanity notice
this it's kind of an extreme perspective
but it exists opposed to Magneto's views
right where Magneto is steadfast
protecting mutant kind this guy director
Bravo like so many villains before him
is steadfast protecting humanity and
this is cool this is an interesting idea
because what he does is he basically
says like the fall of the fall of like
motherwald that's nothing like we have a
whole host of things that are working in
the background a whole host of things
that we want to get done from here
that's what was cool because what it
says is what we saw in House of powers
of X that's not the end of it it's
nowhere near the end of it it's a very
small thing now at this point we
transition over to uh to Scott Summers
along with like pretty much his whole
family you also get Gabriel Summers here
now here's an important thing to
understand Gabriel Summers died during
and and in the aftermath of War of Kings
right he's been well he wasn't really
killed he was kind of yanked away into
like a black hole more or less some kind
of gravity well Black Bolt ended up
coming back we never found out what
happened to Gabriel we never found out
what happened to Vulcan he was just gone
now a lot of that was part of the lead
up to Secret Wars and so Marvel I
imagine if it was just kind of a thing
where it was like well they're more or
less gone don't really worry about
explaining it just kind of leave it the
way it is and then whatever happens
happens that kind of seems to have been
a lot of the response with what was
going on there uh and so this is really
like the first real time we're seeing
Vulcan after the event sense of Secret
Wars and all new all different Marvels
but he's a good guy here right there's
no semblance of like I hate my brothers
and I'm a bad guy and I I conquered the
Shiite Empire and I'm going to war with
the creek like we don't really see any
of that going on here and there doesn't
really seem to be any reference to it
it's just kind of a thing that's there
so I think Hickman's just sort of
rolling with it and just kind of saying
hey if you never really read anything
about Vulcan before don't worry about it
just know that he's really powerful uh
he can control all forms of energy and
he's Omega Level and and that's really
it it's cool but like that's pretty much
it and it's interesting to see and it
works and not only that you have these
small things to go on for example like
you literally got cable hanging out with
Raza now of course Raza is like the
weapons guy he's almost kind of like the
gunsmith so to speak of the of the star
Jammers group and it's interesting to
see because like he's got like this
these super Advanced weapons and cables
like little kid cables like freaking out
like I've gotta see that you know and so
on and so forth so the guys who aren't
really familiar with what's going on
here let me backped a little bit let me
offer some explanations so so when it
comes to the star Jammers this is an
idea introduced way back during Chris
claremont's run and what he did is he
said initially it was believed that
Cyclops and his brother were thrown out
of a plane given parachutes and they
landed you know more or less safely
after their plane crashed after their
plane went down Claremont came back and
changed some of that and said actually
the shiar abducted his mother and his
father and uh they were just kind of
taken out into space and eventually his
mom died and uh and and Corsair uh who's
the leader the leader of the sarjammers
formed the star Jammers as was
essentially a pirate group out there
right they're space pirates right so
think of them as like a pirate version
of the Guardians of the Galaxy for what
you've seen in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in a lot of ways uh because of
that they're pretty capable but these
are the members that you're basically
seeing here right Raza and and uh and
Hephzibah you know you're seeing like
chode you're seeing a lot of these
characters here who are just part of the
star Jammers group and the reason why
they're here is there are a lot of
there's a lot of history there right the
sword Jammers are like extended family
for Scott Summers right Corsair is his
biological dad and then the star Jammers
are part of the team so it's like a
cyclops ride as one X-Men you know it's
this kind of family thing there's been a
lot of history these teams that fought
side by side with each other there's a
lot of closeness that goes on between
these guys uh with regards to Cable
being a kid this was covered in the uh
the new X-Force run that I think was
written by Greg Pac although I'm not
going to swear to it but the idea is
that you had cable who's been around for
a long long time right like the adult
version of cable because of the fact
that he's gone back in time and most of
the time Stream So Much his younger
counterpart killed him he was just like
you've been screwing up time
consistently since you've been alive
right like you just you're a walking
retc machine like the X-Men are like hey
we want to do something or The Avengers
want to do something and then Here Comes
cable jump and have a crack in the
ground don't do that guys you're gonna
screw up the time stream you're kind of
a hassle so basically
like his younger self ended up killing
him off and it was a way for Marvel
anyway to kind of remove the idea that
Cable's just sort of gonna fix
everything all the time and so that's
that's why his younger part is younger
counterpart it's currently here now we
also talked about that in the return of
Cyclops right when Cyclops was
resurrected we cover that as well so you
guys are welcome to go check that out oh
but there's some cool discussion that
goes on now one of the important things
that really takes place here is Corsair
starts talking to Cyclops and he says
look man I can't agree with everything
that you're doing here it's cool that
you guys have formed your own island
nation but you have to understand
humanity is coming from the perspective
of fear and so what you've basically
done here is you've created an ion
you've created a nation state under
yourself and then you've gathered every
single person that humanity is afraid of
into a singular location as far as
humanity is concerned you're making War
preparations it's you know you could be
doing anything you could be gathering
all these mutants together and then
training them to become like you know
military capable and then you're going
to send them out into the world and
Conquer Humanity you can betraying them
to become humanitarians so they're going
to go out and they're going to heal the
world but because humanity is governed
by fear in this regard they're going to
deviate to the worst case scenario so
yes it's cool that you're doing that but
you might also will be creating more
problems than you are benefits at the
end of the day though Cyclops response
is we'll deal with that threat as it
comes for right now we're doing the
right thing we're protecting our kind as
best we can so it's one of these things
where it's like what the X-Men are doing
on Earth has not gone oh notice across
the entirety of the universe and it
makes sense right because some of the
most powerful people are on earth and so
Earth is constantly monitored by all
these various extraterrestrial races
because who in the heck knows when
things are going to pop off right so as
a result of this what we end up doing is
we end up jumping back to the Orca space
and we end up having this conversation
that takes place with director Dava and
one of the things about this is that
Killian's wife remember she was the she
was a scientist who was on board one of
the vessels when killing himself was
destroyed the response to davo is you
know like where they're talking about
that and he's like yeah some of this is
my fault but at the end of the day we're
doing the right thing this this chick is
just kind of like hey look I'm not too
worried about that because we can bring
my husband back now this is a very easy
thing to overlook because it's like okay
so like whatever she can bring her
husband back that's not the takeaway
from this who cares if her husband comes
back nobody cares if Killian comes back
what matters about this is that if she
can resurrect her husband she can
resurrect anybody else and that means
that we could see The Return of Bolivar
Trask we can see The Return of like
almost any of these characters out there
who have or could possibly continue to
be major threats against the mutant
population right so like William Striker
leading the purifiers different things
like that like imagine if that was the
case right you had you have the
purifiers of William Striker basically
this crazy religious fundamentalists you
know Evangelical group who thinks God
wants them to kill mutants and they're
backed by like some of the best science
and technology in the Marvel Universe
right like they have all this money and
all this technology backing them who
knows what kind of strikes they could
launch against against all of uh all of
mutant kind and so it's it's cool to see
there's a lot of possibilities that can
come out of this and that's why things
like this are so important is because
it's not the immediate statement that's
made by virtue of I can resurrect my
husband it's all the possibilities that
can come out of it all the things that
can come later on down the line because
that's the nature of Jonathan Hickman
writing
okay so we are finally getting around to
the Marauders and I know I promise I
would or at least I said I would do it
last week I got super tied up and super
distracted there were well a lot of you
guys know there was a lot of things
going on but uh but we're covering
Marauders right now here's here's the
thing here's what's going on with Dawn
of X dawn of X may or may not have a
singular cohesive storyline that unites
everything it may have that they may end
up kind of building up to that or
whatever the case is the reality is that
at the moment dawn of X is a branding
initiative right so think of it like
dark rain dark rain was not a story arc
I guess it kind of was a Loosely based
story arc surround you know evolving
Norman Osborne basically taking over
shield and then dismantling it and
replacing it with hammer his own company
and so on and so forth but by and large
dawn of X is a branding initiative
meaning that it's basically designed to
signify a relaunch of the various
characters right so it's like Heroes
Reborn from back in the day and so the
idea behind this is that this is
designed to basically give us like whole
new titles and whole new teams and
Marvel's dumping them like gangbusters
it's insane within the span of like two
to three weeks we got more orders and
then we get Excalibur we get X-Force we
get fallen angels we get all kinds of
stuff coming out of this like it's
insane all they can content that they're
dropping and it's going to be like like
something something new is coming out
every week and so we're going to cover
it every week but it's kind of Bonkers
anyway Marauders this is kind of
interesting because when I first saw
this my immediate thought was the exact
same as pretty much everybody else who's
been reading X-Men for any real measure
of time and it was like the Marauders of
Mr Sinister right it was like okay so
like we're doing a book about Mr
sinister's Marauders but then they
released the roster for and I was like
this is not Mr sinister's Marauders this
is about as far as you get from Mr
sinister's Marauders but obviously I'm
like I'm kind of down with that right
because they got two Omega Level mutants
on there right you got storm and you got
Iceman and honestly I kind of think
Bishop can be Omega Level if they if
they adjust his powers I guess they
tweak his powers a little bit but I'm
sorry they have three they have Emma
Frost on the team as well so it's like
dude this is this is kinda nuts but what
this does is this initially picks up
with basically the mutants grabbing some
mutants who basically gather together in
uh in Central Park New York and then
leading him into one of the uh one of
the gates of krakowa now remember we
covered this during house and powers of
X so I'm not gonna go super hardcore
into this but the idea here is that in
order for the mutant mutant land right
the mutant country of krakowa to be able
to like grab different mutants from
different locations and bring them in at
any point in time Gates can be sprouted
up now a lot of those Gates were created
artificially by krakowa in different
locations just because of the fact that
it was so huge right like Russia is a
huge place these Gates crop up they pop
up in different locations and then
basically mutants are LED and you know
LED through those Gates into the island
of krakowa now remember cocoa can decide
who gets in and who doesn't get in but
at the same time the gates also function
in such a way that if you're not a
mutant you can't access it and the
problem with this is that when Kitty
Pride goes to walk through the gate she
breaks her nose when she basically hits
what's essentially just saw the material
and this can go a couple different ways
it can go in the form of the fact that
kitty pride is not a mutant and can't
access it which begs the question how in
the world should you ever manage to pass
through them before or crook was not
letting her through and if Krakow is not
letting her through then the question
becomes why why is gracoa not letting
her through the gates and that's kind of
the question being asked here because
what this does is it basically leads to
Kitty Pride really sometime later
alongside her Dragon Lockheed heading
towards this island where all these
mutants are basically you know doing
their thing they're having like
essentially like a great big huge party
is really what's going to be going want
but she still can't access the gates
here and that's where the story starts
to shift right that's where the Story
begins to shift here and the reason why
is because with Katie Pride being unable
to access these Gates and what it's not
really being given a definitive answer
as to why then one of the things we find
out of course is that she was basically
running like a like Aaron's a wolverine
it's kind of crazy because like
Wolverine comes running out of nowhere
right he's like kitty did you get all
this stuff and she's like yes I got it
all so it's like what in the world of
Wolverine what you comes back with like
beer and a case of whiskey and it makes
sense right like like so so you end up
getting this grocery list right like
Logan's shopping list right so you get
ribs from Rendezvous in Memphis I've
never even heard of the restaurant
there's Canadian Club whiskey which I've
never had beer Cubano sandwiches which I
have had and they're amazing there's
Pomade there's coffee like basically
she's just running like a smuggling
operation more or less for Wolverine but
the story really begins to shift and it
begins to pick up where she's
telepathically contacted by Emma Frost
and the reason why is because if you
guys recall during our videos on house
and powers of X the idea behind having
basically like this sort of black market
trading system for the different
medicines and things like that of
krakowa was to really operate in two
fronts the first one was for mutants to
basically wholly engineer this kind of
trading system right so there would be
the front side of the selling process
which is to say all the countries out
there that basically support prakoa and
say like we support what it is a mutants
want to do they're the ones who are
going to be able to buy the medicines
and the various things that cocoa can
offer in order to improve the lives of
humanity those who don't support cocoa
don't get any of that stuff right which
I really agree with right you know I
really agree with it but in order to
kind of keep things in somewhat of an
equitable balance the mutants are also
the ones controlling the black market so
they kind of control the price of goods
on the black market in order to ensure
there's kind of a going back and forth
but the reality of this is that by
creating a black market and basically
saying those of you guys who do not who
who publicly do not support KOA but
privately want to get your hands on
their medicine then we can do that for
you now they don't really know it's the
mutants who are pulling the strings they
don't really know it's the mutants who
are doing it as far as they're concerned
it's some shady clandestine organization
or group somewhere just making all this
happen but because of the fact that a
lot of these countries that don't
support krakowa are in turn keeping
their mutant population captive by
serving as kind of a black market
Shipping Company what it also does is it
gives them access to those underground
places that aren't really letting the
mutant population go and so because that
by operating is kind of a black market
organization it gets them into places
they wouldn't normally be able to get
into and then in turn they can Liberate
the mutants in that particular
geographical location so it's a pretty
smart move right it's underhanded as
hell but it's a pretty smart move and
that's the really the proposition that
Emma Frost had pitched to Kitty Pride
like is this something that you want to
be a part of and kitty probably been
thinking about it for quite some time
but ultimately Emma Frost response is I
need a definitive answer here I need to
know are you in or are you out so that's
when we kind of get this Revelation that
there are all these different places
Russia so on and so forth in Brazil they
have these kind of hounds they basically
track down mutants or at least keep
mutants from being able to access the
gates but these gates in different
locations are all cordoned off by
military officials or government
officials or what have you and they're
not letting people get through they're
not letting their mutant population
leave now for some places for example
Russia when Bobby Drake goes there and
uh Bobby Drake is immediately attacked
in some cases it's because mutants are
used right we talked about it and uh
talked about that in our video on
Colossus explained that when Colossus
first developed his powers his powers
started popping up at a time time when
Russia wasn't Exterminating their their
meat and population instead they were
forcing their meat in population to work
as soldiers of the Russian military
hence the Winter Guard but where
Colossus was safe from that fate a lot
of mutants weren't and so what that
basically meant is that Russia basically
managed to get their hands on a lot of
superpowered beings and they forced them
to work for the Russian government
that's what's going on here that's why
there's opposition here when Bobby Drake
shows up it's like no no all
super-powered beings are basically tools
of the state they work for us they do
what we tell them to we're not letting
them go like we're not letting you guys
you know walk away from all this at the
same time there's some plot threads that
are thrown in here right like you end up
going to Taiwan end up going to Taipei
and you end up having this this woman
who basically gets out in front of the
the news cameras and everything and says
my husband went through one of those
Gates and he vanished and what happened
to him and I don't know what's going on
with him and you have Bishop who shows
up and says look we're investigating
your husband disappearance we don't have
any record of him entering through the
gates of uh any any of the gates in
Taipei so like obviously the implication
seems to be she's lying these are plot
threads that Jerry Dugan is going to
build up over time but it's a cool
little moment here it's a cool little
scenario to see like these little things
thrown in you know thrown out here and
there in terms of people who are lying
about what's going on people who are
trying to curtail public opinion to
achieve a particular goal is a pretty
smart move but from here what it does is
it switches over to the reintroduction
of pyro now when it comes to the
character of pyro and Marvel Comics
Urban a couple different versions
there's a version that anybody who ever
watched X-Men the Animated Series or has
been reading X-Men for a long long time
are aware of which is Saint John
allardyce which I'm pretty sure that's
how you pronounce his name then there's
Simon Lasker who's the most recent
version uh this one here is Saint John
right this is the the classic version of
pyro in an effort to kind of clean up a
lot of characters that were deemed as
kind of unnecessary or to rework them or
something like that Marvel either got
rid of them or they basically soft
rebooted them uh and with the character
of Saint John he died in 2001 right he
was removed in Cable number 87. he ended
up coming back a few years later during
the X necrosia storyline but was killed
off yet again and so as a result of that
what you have now is this this classic
version back here again but he's not
really as brutal as his old school
version Instead This is a lot more
light-hearted now that's one of the
things about how Jerry Dugan's writing
this story and I hope it's one of the
things you've noticed so far is this is
far more lighthearted than like a lot of
the other stories that we've seen right
it's not nearly as serious in tone as
like Jonathan Hickman's storytelling now
that's the nature of Jerry Dugan and
it's one of the reasons why he shines so
spectacularly when he wrote Deadpool at
least I loved his his handling of
Deadpool but it's one of the reasons why
it was kind of like nah when you were
reading the infinity War storyline Jerry
Dugan does better with like
light-hearted and comedic stories than
he does with like dark and and hardcore
stories right that's always kind of been
my take on him and so as a result of
that that's why this story seems a lot
lighter than you would normally expect
and it's one of the reasons why right
off the bat storms like well one you're
drafted onto this team and two you can't
kill people
you can't kill humans which is kind of
what he's always done right I mean he
has no love for Humanity now one of the
other other things that I want to kind
of clear up here is the nature of Pyro's
Powers because this will become
important as we get further and further
into what's essentially going to be the
Marauders comics and and Marvel pyro
does not have the ability to create fire
he can't do that what pyro can do is
control existing fire now sometimes it's
amplifying the size of that fire right
he could take what's basically a candle
and expand it out into this great BQ so
he could do all kinds of stuff create
all kinds of different designs and all
kinds it's very very intricate in terms
of any ability to do that but it's why
you see him walk around with basically
flamethrowers attached to him because he
can't actually create fire that's not
really what he does it'd be cool if he
did because then he would be overpowered
as hell but he can't actually make it so
that's kind of something that you sort
of have to go with now having said that
the power of pyro is still pretty cool
but what really comes out of this this
is really the big thing to focus on here
is the power of kitty prod and the
reason why is because Kitty pride is
probably one of the most underrated of
the X-Men in terms of what she could
really do like if you if you really pull
out the stops and if you give us a story
like what we're getting ready to see
right here where it's like okay so Kitty
pride has always kind of been the
cheerleader of the X-Men until she
wasn't until she graduated it became
kind of like one of the leaders of the
team and different things like that but
no one's ever really shown what she's
truly capable of like this does and is
absolutely amazing and the reason why is
because what you have there is is one of
these Russian guys who basically uses a
solar dampening suit so when it comes to
him being able to touch anybody out
there being able to blast storm or
Iceman like it'll dampen their powers
it'll take their powers away temporarily
but the issue is that contact has to be
made with Kitty Pride it doesn't work
that way so the first thing she does is
of course she phases then she gets up to
the guy takes them down and that guy's
immediately out of the picture from
there she single-handedly dismantles
every single soldier like she basically
like either either she like they face
through her and she knocks them out
there's a couple there's one time where
she basically like shoots guys with
bullets uh which is kind of cool I mean
shooting them is not the biggest thing
ever but the cool one of the coolest
moments is she grabs a gun she phases it
into two guys legs and makes it solid
again and so they basically got like a
gun in their legs which is kind of
screwed up she phases into a tank she
rips grenades out of out of the sky you
know she steals a sword from another guy
after incapacitating him it seems kind
of uh kind of like okay whatever this is
like a small little thing but here's the
thing you can't hit what you can't touch
and that's why Kitty pride is probably
one of the most powerful of the X-Men is
it's the reason why if you read the
story Wolverine um Enemy of the State
the what if story where he basically
kills all the superheroes of the Marvel
Universe it ends up being Kitty Pride
who's the one that takes him out because
of what use is the ability to to slash
through anything with adamantium claws
if you can't touch it that's one of the
coolest things about Kitty pride is like
in this moment you kind of get her as
this character awards like she can take
all comers and it's kind of a cool thing
because I mean the only way to really
get around that is to kind of wear her
down down right to the point where she's
exhausted and she can't really keep
going anymore because it's just too much
for her to take mental or physical or
whatever the case happens to be but of
course pyro ends up channeling the uh
the fire of Lockheed and then in turn
you know using dragon's breath basically
like spray down a whole bunch of guys
it's pretty cool it's pretty awesome and
so as a result of this like one of the
one of the people that they're
liberating has like an iPhone which kind
of begs the question like if they're
stuck in a camp why do they have an
iPhone but still like one of the people
has that has an iPhone basically and is
recording this message of kitty pride
and she's like and it's kind of it's
kind of cool right because it reminds me
of The A Team like it's like if you're a
mutant uh and you can't get to krakowa
then the Marauders will bring you home
right like we're The A-Team
it's kind of how it feels right it's
kind of how it comes across and that's
that's why I love the Marauders so much
because it's not a super like oh man
things are popping off everything's
going crazy it's just a good
old-fashioned fun read and that's really
what it should be right the nature of
comics it's not the politics right it's
it's the the enjoyment of the comics
like it's fun reading the story that's
the cool that's one of the reasons why I
love the Marauders it's fun it's just a
fun story to read and I'm really excited
to see where it goes like I'm really
excited to see what happens especially
if they start encountering like these
super op broken mutants like these these
super broken mutants so what you end up
getting is once they leave Kitty Pride
starts addressing the storm and when
she's talking to storm one of the things
to understand here is that she's not
addressing storm as a member of the
X-Men she's a dressing storm as a
surrogate mother and the reason why is
because if you haven't if you haven't
been reading X-Men for a long time it's
something that's kind of easily missed
something that you're not really
familiar with but when Katie Pride first
showed up in the X-Men she was like 15
years old I think and so basically with
the character of storm she became a kind
of mother for Kitty Pride right like
helping her navigate the Waters of what
it meant to become a woman when she was
changing and she was going through this
biological process in terms of her body
you know growing and so on and so forth
a lot of the lessons that kitty probably
learned over the course of her life that
led her to becoming the superhero she is
today we're taught basically to her by
storm and so the relationship between
the two is very much mother and daughter
and it's one of the reasons why Kitty
probably basically tells storm I need
you to stay here I need you with me like
I need you to stay with me here while
I'm while I'm going on all this the
really probably two of the closest
friends and so of course following that
the Marauders are completely in fully
formed right you've got pyro you've got
Kitty Pride you got Iceman and you got
storms so why don't off the bat you
already got two Omega Level mutants here
which is going to make the team an
absolute Powerhouse an absolute like
horse of a team it's kind of nuts
okay so continuing on with our dawn of X
series of videos we're covering
Excalibur now remember for those of you
guys who are joining us we're going
through each one of these individually
for the first story arc and then after
that we'll just kind of go from there
right one of the things that I believe
when it comes to new launches or or new
Comics is you should always give it one
story arc and then let that story arc
determine whether or not you enjoy it
right you can't really determine whether
or not a story is going to be good based
on like the first comic right it doesn't
really work that way because things can
change drastically over the course of a
single a single line of comics right
like literally the story of superior
Spider-Man like Dr Octopus is just like
a villain who gets the body of Peter
Parker but it's like it becomes an
amazing Story by the time you get to the
end right so you can't really use like a
single issue to judge the whole thing
but uh here's the thing about here's the
thing about Excalibur the way this is
being written the way this is this is
being done it's really really cool but
if you don't care anything about like
Camelot and like Morgan Le Faye and
things like that you're not gonna like
this story
because it's literally 100 that stuff
but we need to talk about this so the
idea of Camelot is that in Marvel comic
it largely follows the Arthurian Mythos
right Camelot was a kingdom of King
Arthur he had gwynevere you had Lancelot
all that kind of cool stuff um
ultimately in Marvel Superheroes number
17 in 1968 Camelot fell and the result
was that it was moved to Otherworld now
Otherworld is a dimension that exists in
Marvel Comics that's basically outside
the Multiverse right so it kind of
exists as part of it but not necessarily
at the same time and so far that the
reason why is because what you have is
the wizard Merlin and Merlin basically
created a group called The Captain
Britain Corps and the Captain Britain
core is this organization that's like
the Green Lantern Corps from DC Comics
but instead of the Green Lantern Corps
protecting each sector of space the
Captain Britain Corps each member
protects its own Universe now for the
most part it doesn't really matter just
because there are such exceedingly
powerful beings in those universes the
cattle Britain couldn't even begin to
hope to stand a chance against but it
works because you can call in a bunch of
Captain britons to face off against a
particular threat but that's one of the
things that's kind of going on here
Morgan lefaye is probably one of the
more powerful beings in Marvel Comics
when it comes to using magic Ashu is one
of the students of Merlin uh she is she
was actually considered to be the
replacement for Doctor Strange after he
lost his ability to become sorcerer
Supreme when she decides to Reign
Hellfire down on you like it's coming
she's really really really really
powerful but the other thing about this
is is Arthur Pendragon King Arthur
himself during Dan Abbott's run on
Hercules which I think is considered
Hercules Volume 2 in 2016. Arthur
Pendragon was summoned by Hercules and I
believe he fought in that that small
little war that little conflict that was
going on there but essentially since
then leading up until now he's vanished
we didn't really know what was going on
with him now a lot of that was due to
the fact that at the time Marvel wasn't
really publishing anything on King
Arthur so it was just kind of like okay
whatever you know it's out there doing
its thing but within the confines of
this story The the whole idea is like
he's vanished like we don't really know
where he is or what's going on the other
thing that's going on here is that
within the Kingdom of Camelot itself
what you essentially have here at least
as Morgan lafay interprets it is kind of
like an invasion of sorts it's this idea
that there are forces within Camelot
working against her now Technically
she's the steward of Camelot she's
basically the one who's essentially
ruling in place of King Arthur and so
because of the fact that she was the one
that initially led to the downfall of
Camelot and she is more often than not
depicted as a villain it does kind of
make sense that they would be working
against her but we don't really know who
the White Witch is we're not really sure
exactly what all is going on there
instead what we end up doing here is we
actually end up picking up with with
psylocke with Betsy Braddock now one of
the things that I want to point out here
is this idea of psylocke basically going
back to being a Caucasian woman again
the reason why is is back in icanny
X-Men 256 Chris Claremont had this idea
to basically rework psylocke in her
entirety and basically put her mind more
or less in the body of a Japanese woman
named Quantum now that's that's probably
explained better in our video on
psylocke explain so you're welcome to go
check it out the long and short of it is
that for decades psylocke was basically
in the body of a Japanese woman and that
was kind of her identity going forward
right that's how people associated with
her most people who got into the X-Men
and like the 90s remember psylocke as
that version this really ran up until
mystery and madrapore as part of the
return of Wolverine and the reason why
was because the return of Wolverine and
Marvel Comics kind of marks this
paradigm shift with regards to the X-Men
right in so far is Marvel's no longer
just kind of shuffling them to the
background and whatever happens happens
instead it was kind of bringing them
back into the Forefront and really
leading up to Jonathan Hickman's run on
the team and so as a result of that
there were a lot of changes that were
made to existing characters most of
those came by way of Jonathan Hickman
during house and powers of X when
different X-Men were basically
resurrected but during mystery and
madraport psylock got her body back she
got her original body back and so that's
why right now when you look at her she's
essentially her original Caucasian self
the funny thing about this is she
basically ends up going to visit with
apocalypse and this is kind of an
important thing because what this does
is it shows what apocalypse is doing now
and that was really the big question
that I had going out you know coming out
of house and powers of X is what's
apocalypse doing what's his role going
to be right if he's part of the mutant
council is he biting his time to
basically somehow take over and and like
Crush everybody or test them all or
whatever the case is what's going on
with this character and what this really
shows is that apocalypse is actually
turning over a new Leaf the biggest
issue with this and one of the big
things that apocalypse is trying to
figure out at the moment is why it is at
one of their doors from kakoa cannot
access other worlds this is kind of a
cool thing because what this shows is
that apocalypse is aware of places like
Otherworld he's aware of other dimension
and the Multiverse right he's aware of
more that there's more than just Earth
but what this does is this basically
picks up with a holy new character kind
of transitioning away from kakoa and it
picks up with a holy new character now
this character's name is Marianna Stern
and in reality she's part of What's
called the coven what is a coven solar
Blackwood this as far as I'm aware is
Holy new but in reality it's this the
cuffing that she's a part of isn't the
real big takeaway here the real big
takeaway here is how magic Works in in
Marvel Comics this is kind of a big
thing here right this is a huge
Revelation that goes on here because
while they're you know running their
enchantments and so on and so forth what
they end up doing is basically
unintentionally invoking uh Morgan lafay
and so far as Morgan lafaye realizes
that somebody outside of other world
basically in the main Marvel universe is
using magic and ultimately she deems it
as somebody who seems to be kind of
intruding on her on her territory now of
course she kind of jumps into this and
basically says like my entire Kingdom's
under attack I'm trying to figure out
what's going on here even even Morgan Le
Faye doesn't really know what's
happening and so what she basically does
is she tasks the Kevin Blackwood she
says like you guys need to go figure out
what's going on if you don't figure out
what's going on I'm cutting magic off to
all of you and that's a really important
thing here and the reason why is because
the use of magic and Marvel Comics comes
in a couple different forms right you
have magic like the Scarlet Witch or
like Doctor Strange which is usually
magic given to them by like other
entities and and beings that are out
there right so doctor strange doesn't
really have magic and so far as is
inherent to him he uses the abilities of
like of like watum and and you know
sitarak and so on and so forth and
Scarlet Witch channels the power of
c'thon but what you also have in Marvel
Comics are beings like Agatha Harkness
and Agatha Harkness is an actual witch
right she you know Royal boils Royal in
trouble you know using a giant cauldron
different things like that killing
rodents and so on and so forth she uses
actual magic but the magic she uses is
channeled directly from Camelot itself
from the magic of Merlin and so the
result of this is that in order for her
to be able to continue using magic and
even the coven to be able to continue
using magic Morgan lafay basically has
to keep those channels open which she
can close at any point in time what it
does is kind of offer an explanation on
the other half of magic and Marvel that
we always knew was there but never
really got a full in-depth explanation
on in terms of how it worked or how
these abilities were channeled and given
to various people this is kind of a cool
thing because what it means is that
Morgan lafaye does not know who's
attacking her kingdom so we're not
really given all the answers in this
we're just kind of left wondering a
little bit which makes sense because
it's the first issue wouldn't really
make any sense to wrap the whole Arc up
in the first issue what reason would you
have to read the other five but there's
other there's other cool little things
that come out of this for example Jamie
Braddock is basically resurrected so
he's essentially brought back from the
dead that's one of the things to keep in
mind here guys is over the years between
House of M running up until the modern
era a lot of X-Men have died right like
a lot of mutants out there have been
killed by one means or another what dawn
of X is designed to do is kind of reset
the X-Men back to the status quo to not
necessarily pretend like nothing after
House of we know all that stuff took
place but it's designed to kind of bring
the team back to its roots and so
resurrecting and bringing back a lot of
these mutants who have been away for a
long time it's kind of a cool thing to
see here because as we know with Jamie
Braddock he can manipulate reality right
so he's an exceedingly powerful
character to have on their team it's
very important that he's there but for
the character of Apocalypse it's like
you know why in the world aren't these
things being enabled right like why
aren't we able to to basically you know
access this portal and get into the and
get into other world because there are
mutant beings who reside in them and so
the question is how do we access that
area and so it's kind of a cool thing
because what you end up basically
getting it's Bessie Braddock and Captain
Britton who essentially teleport to this
location now here's the important thing
to understand about Captain Britain for
all the abilities that Brian Braddock
has his powers are not strictly his own
and the reason why I say that is because
when Brian Braddock was was presented
with a possibility or at least presented
with the offering of becoming Captain
Britain by Merlin and his daughter Roma
he was basically presented with two
artifacts the first one was the Amulet
of right and the second one was the
sword of Might and the idea behind these
two things is that depending on what you
choose uh your role and your costume and
your powers to a degree will change but
regardless it's basically an offering to
become a Captain Britain Ryan Braddock
chose the Amulet of right and what the
emulator did is basically as long as he
wore it around his neck it would allow
him to channel the powers of Captain
Britain it would give him flight and
energy projection and and durability
different things like that the sort of
Might itself would basically allow
powers that were almost identical to the
traditional Captain written abilities
but in turn uh you would also have like
this you know insanely powerful artifact
in terms of a weapon now the amulet
represented life and the sword
represented death but it's kind of a
cool little thing the idea behind this
though is that Brian Braddock channeling
the the you know power of the captain
written Court well he's not all powerful
he is a guy that you do want on your
side but he's pretty capable in terms of
his abilities the issue is that with him
traveling basically to another world
alongside Betsy Braddock what we end up
learning is that what's going on with
this device here at least you know this
is this kind of invasion that she sees
is essentially the springing up of these
portals by mutants from cocoa right so
this idea that this portal basically
sprung up she doesn't really know how it
works or what's going on with it and so
she ultimately ended up kind of cutting
it off so nobody could get through that
portal and into the realm of other world
which is within her power to do
apocalypse and his guys don't know this
and that's kind of the question that's
being asked here the issue with this is
that Morgan lafay alongside Mordred have
always been enemies of Captain Britain
and so of course when Captain Britain
shows up here it's her chance to seize
his power and to basically take it
Merlin has been dead for a long time and
so has Roma right so it's not like
they're going to step in and they're
going to protect Captain Britain and all
these guys that's not going to play out
that way instead you have psylocke
fending off against uh Morgan lafaye's
bestie canvas she's no real match here
and so as a result of that what ends up
happening is Morgan le Faye basically
transforms Captain Britain into her
Black Knight now this depiction of the
Black Knight of Morgan lafay is not to
be confused with Dane Whitman right the
wielder of the Ebony Blade which is to
say the sword that basically becomes
more and more evil more or less as time
goes on demands blood and so on and so
forth these are two distinctly different
things all this is designed to do is
basically illustrate a corrupted Captain
Britain more or less you know a guy that
basically Works in service of Morgan
lafay and can't really do anything on
his enemy he can to a degree like he
goes as far as to give the amulet
directly to psylocke so that she can
Channel his power and essentially become
the new Captain Britain but while all
that's going on you end up having
apocalypse who gathers together Rogue
and trinary and basically uses rogue's
abilities as I mean to kind of try to
tap into the power of the Cocoon gate
and then in turn enter in and bring out
Betsy Brock the problem with this and
the issue that you end up facing while
all this is going down is that
ultimately the end result is achieved
this sort of Betsy Braddock comes flying
out but the coconut gate is shattered
and what this does is kind of create
like this mental backlash right and
we've seen that happen before with the
character of Rogue if Rogue is basically
if she's exposed to too much power too
fast it'll put her into a comatose state
and that's exactly what happens here
right she basically ends up going into a
catatonic State Betsy Braddock
essentially you know is kind of left
there to face off against you know the
Black Knight of of uh of Morgan lafaye
as well as Morgan lafay herself which
ultimately she ends up using the amulet
to essentially make her Escape as best
she can becoming the new Captain Britain
in the process but for the character of
Rogue this is what I want to talk about
here for a second for the character of
Rogue her being left in a comatose state
here I want to kind of jump back to
What's called the hekatu right this is
kind of a big thing the hecka tomb was
this massive bomb this kind of weapon
that was created by the shiar Empire
that was designed for the purpose of
inflicting massive loss of life right
but the idea was that when Rogue touched
it she ended up absorbing all these
Minds right just like billions and
billions of lines all at the same time
and the result of that is that it was
exceedingly overwhelming to her and shut
her down and put her put her in a
comatose state where she laid until
after the events of Messiah complex but
that's kind of the big thing here is
that what this does is one it knocks out
Rogue which is one of the more powerful
characters of of the X-Men but it also
gives us potential into what is it she
saw in the moments that this this uh
this Gateway basically shattered Betsy
Braddock comes out as the new Captain
Britain which is cool but the biggest
takeaway from all this this is the
biggest thing to kind of keep in mind
here is that what you end up getting is
Marianna Stern who basically kills her
cousin right like kills the the solar
Blackwood coven and then leaves and
joins the clanic Hava the higher she
becomes a high priestess for the clanic
habit and this is important because the
clanic Hava has been shown as both
allies of Apocalypse as well as enemies
of Apocalypse what this looks like is
the version of clanocaba that basically
warships apocalypse and so what it looks
like is going on here is apocalypse has
engineered all of this stuff for what
reason we don't know but apocalypse
seems to have engineered all of this set
all these things in motion so you can
make his move somewhere along the line
and then implement that whatever plan it
is that he wants to implement but based
on this first issue it looks like
apocalypse is doing business as usual
he's being a bad guy
okay so we are getting into the first
issue of the new volume of New Mutants
and I'm excited about this actually I'm
pretty hyped about this it really is a
good throwback to the old New Mutants
Comics but if I'm being honest with you
guys Hickman is writing it and I love
Hickman's writing this feels more like
Generation X than New Mutants right it's
kind of it's kind of crazy in terms of
how this this whole thing goes down but
what this does is this initially picks
up with rain Sinclair with with really
like wolf Spain now here's the thing
here's it's like a really good way to
open this and the reason why is because
wolf Spain is one of the original New
Mutants right so the way this played out
Marvel Comics like this this is Eon this
is like decades ago like eons and eons
ago so the way this played out is you
had the X-Men and the X-Men were a
really really popular team and so Marvel
basically came along and I want to say
it was Jim shooter who went to Louise
Simonson and Chris Claremont and said
give me a new X-Men title or a new
Mutant title if you don't I'm gonna have
somebody else do it okay so they ended
up creating the New Mutants and and the
way this played out is and it was kind
of a cool Revelation the way this played
out is you had mutants out there who
were like usually discovered by Charles
Xavier right like he'd put on his
cerebral helmet and he'd look around and
say there's a mutant over there and then
like all the X-Men would go there he
would go there whatever the case is and
they would talk to them and sometimes
they would join the X-Men sometimes they
wouldn't mind they would just say screw
off I'm gonna go commit crimes and then
like the X-Men would fight them later on
or something on those lines the cool
thing about this is that you had more
McTaggart and more McTaggart was
basically just a mutant geneticist at
the time now Hickman has changed a lot
of her character as part of house and
powers of X but back then she was just a
mutant geneticist but what would happen
is that if she came across a mutant who
didn't understand how their powers
worked or she didn't understand how
their powers worked she would work
alongside them to understand it on a
genetic level there were other times
where Xavier would come across a mutant
and he wouldn't understand how their
powers were so he would send them to
Mormon taggard and she would basically
you know work on them and try to figure
out what the case was it was a cool idea
but Rayne Sinclair was a mutant who was
basically found to buy more McTaggart
and brought in and then ultimately the
new Muse were formed after that but the
cool thing about this is that Reign
Sinclair is one of the many mutants
who's been resurrected by the five and
that's officially what Hickman's calling
them now right the five mutants who were
responsible for being able to resurrect
mutants now here's the reason why that
matters is because by saying it's the
five what it does is it makes those five
mutants essential to the process of
Resurrection if any one of those five
mutants die the ability to resurrect
mutants basically goes away like it's
effectively gone and so as a result of
that you need to have them there in
order to be able to pull that off so you
kill any one of those five and most
likely the X-Men cannot resurrect
mutants anymore but as a result of those
five uh mutants 2 have basically been
killed off over the years are
systematically being brought back right
so you've got Daniel Moonstar who
basically makes her return you've got
Karma who makes her return Karma was an
interesting character right technically
they call her Shan and I guess that's
really how you pronounce it but it's x i
Apostrophe a and I think is how it's
actually spelled she had the ability she
had uh I'm sorry she had telepathy and
she could possess people which was
really really cool uh wolf Spain was
basically like a little mini werewolf
kind of character right she could turn
one of those characters that look like a
werewolf it was It was kind of cool the
way it played out and then we have the
return of Mondo
I don't know why Mondo is back here
Mondo is a terrible character okay so
the idea behind this is in the old
Generation X Comics right it was
Generation X number three in 1995 by by
Scott lodell and they introduced Mondo
as this this mutant that had the ability
to basically influence or to manipulate
any kind of biological organism that was
out there right so he could interface
and like take on the properties of those
various things but Mondo was introduced
as a friend of Emma Frost's younger
sister uh and the younger sister Emma
Frost tried to like try to basically get
herself in the hellfire club by having
him captured it was weird anyway
um ultimately they're defeated by
Generation X and uh and the result is
that Mondo's brought onto the team this
runs for about five years until Jay
Faber gets on gets his hands on
Generation X and in 1999 or 2000 I want
to say it was February 2000 there was a
story that ran in issue 60 and 61. and
what you ended up learning is that Mondo
as he existed in Generation X up to that
point was not actually Mondo it was a
clone created by black Tom Cassidy who
was designed to infiltrate Generation X
and it was basically a clone of the
super villain Mondo who worked with
black Tom Cassidy it was weird it was
comics in the late 2000s didn't really
make a whole lot of sense the way things
are going down here this looks like the
Mondo clone is really kind of what it
looks like in terms of like this guy
being a good guy and never really being
a bad guy plus there's no real reference
to him ever having been a villain before
at least that's kind of how it seemed
anyway so regardless of the circumstance
the cool thing about this is that Doug
Ramsey Cipher basically walks up on him
and says hey man because you can
interface with like biological organisms
and things along those lines you know
organic and inorganic matter see if you
can interface with perkoa because I want
to talk to it I just want to see if it
can happen and it's kind of weird
because ultimate Laker KOA does right it
interfaces directly through uh through
Mondo and talks to Doug Ramsay which is
kind of cool but it's interesting
because what it does is it really ties
the nature of Mondo at least seemingly
into plant life right the fact remains
here then of course you've got Robert
DeCosta who's basically been brought
back you've got Danielle Moonstar who's
here is it really is kind of a reunion
with all these New Mutants that are here
the only person that's missing is Sam
Guthrie as Cannonball because at the
moment he's currently in Shear space now
in reality this statement kind of
confuses me a little bit and the reason
why is because Paige Guthrie the sister
of Sam died during house and powers of X
right she was husk she was one of the
mutants that was killed during the
assault on mother mold Icarus has
basically been dead since decimation
right so it's like the aftermath of
destination and the war with William
Striker so so I have no idea who Sam
Guthrie's with I have no idea who he's
with at the moment it's kind of weird to
sort of have that thrown in so it may
just be that it's one of those things
where like Icarus was brought back in
some form of fashion and then for
whatever reason was sent to Shear space
I don't really know but that's basically
where Sam is at the moment the result is
that the the New Mutants actually end up
hitching a ride with Corsair and star
Jammers now this is cool I love this
idea of the New Mutants working with
Corsair and his guys but the overall
gist here the overall idea behind this
is essentially the New Mutants are just
screwing stuff up everywhere they go and
it's one of the funny things because
what you end up having is cipher and
mondo who essentially create one of
these uh krakowan portals more or less
in this uh this bio biome basically
that's ran by chode and it's kind of a
funny thing because as soon as chode
realizes what's going on like you
realize there's an imbalance in the
various substances that make up this
biome and then when he gets in there he
starts freaking out and the reason why
is because he had basically found or he
had found these little plants that
really only bloom once in a decade right
like once every 10 years and he had to
get these conditions perfect so he had
to spend years getting these conditions
ripe for these these flowers to bloom
and then when that happens it'll take a
decade before they reach their final
form and they've been killed by by
Cipher and uh and mondo
that was kind of funny that's why I say
this feels like this feels like
generation x man I guess exactly what it
feels like Generation X New Mutants was
pretty serious at the time but I think
Generation X was a little more Carefree
in terms of how it was done it's funny
to me because then you end up switching
over to uh to Raza and Magic now here's
a funny thing Raza is is not really the
muscle of the team but he kind of is
right he's the muscle in so far as he's
probably the one who's the best at
fighting and the funny thing about this
is Magic of course having her sword and
so on is a prodigious fighter as well
and so there's kind of a bet that's
going on here right between the the two
of these uh the two of these guys uh
who's gonna win the fight between the
two the idea is that ultimately if
Robert DeCosta wins then they basically
take Kentucky bourbon off of Corsair
which I'm proud to say is cool because
I'm from Kentucky we basically have two
two Bourbons in Kentucky right like two
Bourbons that matter you've got Woodford
Reserve and you got Buffalo Trace I'm a
Woodford man more so than a Buffalo
Trace man but they're both pretty good
right so it's kind of cool to see this
little bet go on the funny thing about
this is that when this goes down rasa
basically punches magic in the face she
freaks out and then like breaks his
sword in half and cuts off his robotic
arm
so like these are these little moments
you need to kind of remember this for a
second because it'll become important
once we get closer to the end of the
story but what they end up doing is
arriving at the space station
benevolence now here's the important
thing to understand about Shear space CR
space is very much akin to like free
space or scroll space where it's a huge
section of the universe are really of a
particular Galaxy that's kind of
cordoned off for them right it's their
empire nobody gets in nobody gets out
unless they approve it and so the star
jammer is basically sneaking in here is
a pretty dangerous thing because the
star Jammers and the the Shia have a
pretty sketchy history right going all
the way back to the Phoenix of the dark
Phoenix sagas and even before then right
so they've been around for a long time
and constantly at odds because the star
Jammers are basically space pirates and
so as a result of that Corsair kind of
spits the story and basically saying hey
look this Space Station's ran by some
crazy religious despot and and the
result is that if you go in there like
they're gonna bust you and they're gonna
take you to the torture chambers and you
know you gotta stay on the ship because
it's really bad stuff right it's really
really scary out there it's really bad
stuff the problem with Corsair is he's
basically dealing with teenagers he's
dealing with teenagers here and so as a
result of that you end up having Robert
DeCosta who goes off and grass bourbon
so they can all just basically have some
drinks which they're all probably
underage so they really shouldn't but I
guess I wonder if space is considered
international waters like international
territory like the laws the United
States don't apply the United States of
space for those of you guys who
understand this repel reference but it's
it's kind of a funny thing because he's
like okay well I'll go get some Bourbon
and we can take some shots and so the
result of that is that while he's gone
they all basically sneak off because
they're teenagers they do exactly what
you would expect them to do right see
here's this is an important thing to
understand right I know it seems like it
may not be super important and it may
not seem to seem to be you know
something to focus on the fact that they
snuck out but this is what made the New
Mutants and the Generation X Comics so
popular teenagers doing teenage things
teenagers with superpowers doing the
things that they would do if they had
super powers right so like sneaking out
at night you know little things like
that I mean it wasn't necessarily all
just teenage Mischief right there were
some really really amazing stories that
came out of it but it was a small little
things like this that made it so cool
Daniel Moonstar kind of being the mom of
the group different things like that it
was cool how this whole thing went down
the funny thing about this is that when
Robert DeCosta comes back it reminds me
of that opening scene from or not really
the opening scene but that scene from
Robin Hood Men in Tights right well like
Robin of Loxley who's like hey like I
want to confess and I want to reveal
everything that I've done and so on and
so forth and all that kind of good stuff
and the the prison guards like I'll go
tell the warden right so he's like he's
like I'm gonna get a promotion for this
and everything's gonna be awesome so he
comes back and during the time that he's
gone this leads into Robin Hood and then
basically making their escape so the guy
comes back and he's like I told the
warden what was gonna happen I
I'm in deep
which was hilarious at the time and
that's kind of what this says right but
what you end up having here is is
basically them uh really like magic and
everybody having looked at where it was
the stargamers were going to go to and
so they teleport to that location when
they get there everything pops off and
this is when they learn the true nature
of the star jambers in terms of how they
really function as soon as the star
Gamers get in and they realize the New
Mutants are there no the star gamers are
like our job is to steal stuff it's what
we do like we broke in here we stole
things and we're gonna leave and of
course a fight is a breaking out between
the New Mutants and the Shia soldiers
who were there and the star Gamers leave
them and that's the big thing about
about Corsair and his guys they don't
really care about you if you're there
and you can help them along their goal
that's cool but if you get in the way
then there's gonna leave you hanging and
that's just the way it is the stargamers
were almost always like that the only
real exception to that was for the most
part Cyclops Jean Gray and some of the
X-Men and so as a result of that you
basically end up having the new memes
who are essentially cornered and then
here's a cool thing you end up having
chamber uh Jonathan Stars more useless
Powers so for the character of chamber
he was kind of Omega Level but kind of
not it was it was a little weird when it
came to him so when he originally popped
up he was basically this guy who
essentially had his internal body
totally destroyed by the powers that he
possessed this kind of biokinetic flame
that's really a byproduct of his uh
funny like his his total psionic energy
is what he is right like he's a being a
compose a pure psychic energy that just
houses a physical body uh as a result of
that there was a point where really like
for years and years and years uh he kind
of maintained this way until you got
into the events of really the aftermath
of House of M and in the aftermath of
House of M he was one of the the mutants
who consumed some of the blood of
Apocalypse in a new Excalibur number
nine and they became like insanely
powerful following that I'm pretty sure
it was after that you went to New
Mutants volume three issue number 24 as
part of age of X and basically his
physical appearance was restored along
with his powers but Marvel never really
seemed to clarify whether or not he kept
any of the upgrades that apocalypse gave
him by virtue of the blood that he
consumed and I don't think Hickman's
really answering it here he may at some
point along the line but given the
nature of of New Mutants in terms of
what we're seeing here it looks like
it's just classic versions of the
characters right so it would make sense
that because of the way he looks here uh
that he's basically classic Jonathan
Stars more right so just a being of pure
energy houses a physical form it's why
you see that badge like that kind of
mask over its face is because if he
removes it like he does it's just like
this this gaping maw inside of like his
throat and his chest and so on that just
emits huge forms of energy the issue
with this is he he has control over it
but he hasn't reached the full potential
of it right so the result is that he's
able to kind of issue concussive blast
more or less but it's not enough to
really just like incapacitate and
Destroy everybody and so following that
you end up having the star Jammers who
make their way back to uh back to their
ship and they basically tell like Robert
DeCosta yeah like we left all your
friends there man I don't know what to
tell you like they're all basically
there but we're getting ready to leave
like we're leaving right now and it's
crazy because takaza says well what have
they done it gives you reason to just
abandon them like that and chodes like
they ruin my plants and Ros is like the
chick cut off my arm and hebps was like
I don't like kids and uh and and
corsairs like they they took my like you
guys took my whiskey and decost is like
yeah but like you lost that in a bet
like we're serious like well now you
lost his ship so get off my ship it's
funny like it's it's these funny little
moments is these funny little nooks and
crannies and little things that make the
storytelling so incredibly cool but the
cool thing about this is that once the
Costa gets to where they are ultimately
it's like I know a really good space
lawyer a guy who can basically get us
out of this and it's kind of like okay
uh so they're basically stuck here right
like they're captured by the CR which
really kind of begs the question what
comes next because for the most part
anybody who gets captured by the CR it
never really ends well of course Sarah
was captured by the CR along with his
wife and then like she was knocked up by
I think the Ken and then the baby was
taken out ultimately became Vulcan I
think that's how that's how it
originally played out vulcan's origin is
weird there's two different Origins
revoke and I can remember which one's
which but things never really end well
for people and so as a result we get
this really really cool like
advertisement which is basically like
Better Call Saul
having legal trouble Justice is blind
and so are we space lawyer I would watch
a show based on that but anyway uh
that's pretty much where it ends guys so
this is an amazing first issue I
absolutely love it
okay so in a previous video I had talked
about black Tom Cassidy right and I was
like well black Tom Cassidy sucks and
for a long time he did right he could
use wood as a memes to basically shoot
but shoot like plant energy essentially
like concussive blast and heat blast
things like that he was never really
interesting uh he is now dude X-Force is
legit dude he's he's amazing and X-Force
but here's the cool thing about this
right so getting into this X-Force
initially picks up with this kind of
dark Council essentially this kind of
gathering of various individuals from
around the world now here's a funny
thing they're all wearing masks right so
we don't know who all these guys are
it's kind of cool because it almost
feels like a throwback to to Scott
Snyder's run on Batman and the court of
owls but in order for each of them to be
able to be on the council or to prove
who they are there's a blood test and
the blood test will basically determine
if they're mutants or if they're not
mutants now this is an easy thing to
overlook it's a small thing to kind of
look at and say okay cool whatever kind
of the big thing to draw out of this is
that this is yet another example of how
after the formation of krakowa there are
a lot of organizations governments
different groups out there that are
working against mutant kind and it's not
as simple as just like the Marauders I
guess not even the Marauders anymore
because that's a wholly different team
but the forces of Mr Sinister the
purifiers or like the right or the the
Friends of Humanity it's not like it's
just them instead like it's whole
governments working against the entirety
of the mutant population whether it's
because they refuse to let mutants go
from their country or because they're
intentionally trying to sabotage
krakowa's ability to like create plants
and things like that they can heal
people whatever the case is the
character of domino was sent in because
her Herman power is basically luck right
she bims luck to her favorite she was
sent in as a means to infiltrate this
Council and then in turn once the blood
test was done or at least you know once
you try to avoid it immediately your
cover was blown and all these guys went
after right now she was able to take at
least a lot of these guys out or at
least that seemed to be the case until
she's ultimately captured and at that
point she falls off the grid right so we
don't really know what's going on with
it instead what we do here is we pick up
with Wolverine and we pick up with Beast
now beast in this story and here's the
thing this is drawn beautifully right
like the art in this is insanely
gorgeous and so Beast looks amazing in
this story but the cool thing about this
is that this really feel feels like
classic Wolverine right like Wolverine
from like the 1980s is what this feels
like and so far as when he's talking to
Beast there's this Predator that kind of
comes out of nowhere right and basically
like goes to try to attack beast and and
ultimately the Predator is essentially
scared off by BEAST's animal rent and
the initial response is a beast is like
this doesn't make any sense because
krakowa is supposed to be an island
design to basically be a safe haven for
mutant con but the responsible Wolverine
is in every ecosystem there's always
Predators right there's this is an
unavoidable thing they will evolve over
time it's just the way things work he
says the problem with Beast is that
Beast felt safe and this is one of the
best moments of Wolverine he says when
you feel safe that's when you're soft
and this is a cool thing to see when it
comes to Wolverine this this is
something that I've I've really noticed
ever since the events of schism when it
comes to Wolverine I wouldn't really say
he was softer so much as he became more
human and while it's not the worst thing
ever the best story is an involve
Wolverine are when he Taps into his
animal side the part of him that just
kind of like you know you can't trust
anything or anyone uh you always have to
basically be on high alert yes it's like
a super stressful way to live but it's
cool because that's kind of a calling
card of Wolverine's character and it's
interesting to see things that way now
the other part of this is switching
switching over to Black Tom Cassidy so
the funny thing about black Tom Cassidy
is that in his Original Stories he could
shoot this kind of you know concussive
blast more or less by using wood as a
means to channel his power and
Generation X number 25 back in 1997
Marvel changed that right they basically
gave him control over plant-based matter
the problem with this is that between
the stories were written from Generation
X number 25 really up until about now
Marvel never really took full advantage
of that what this does is it basically
gives us that and it makes the most
sense right because while crocoda is a
living Island insofar as it does have
sentience you're talking about a guy who
can control plant life that in turn is
living on a living Island right so as
long as krakowa lets Thomas Castle it
lets black Tom Cassidy do his thing he
can essentially control the plant life
of the planet and this is important
because what it means is he can
communicate with krakowa now it's not as
as easily understood as like Cipher
anchor color right like Cipher actually
understands the language cocoa speaks so
it's like it's like if you were talking
to somebody who speak who spoke French
and now you can speak French then you
understand them perfectly with black Tom
Cassidy it's more of trying to get a
feel for what krakowa means right like
gestures and different things like that
right so if you only spoke English and
another person only spoke French and
they're making gestures towards an
object like I'm talking about that
object eventually you would understand
it over time that's kind of what's going
on with black Tom Cassidy at the moment
but he's a guy who can essentially
control and manipulate an entire Island
and the funny thing about this is he's
basically hit up by Jean Gray now the
reason why this matters is because of
the fact that one Jean Gray is kind of
an early alert system right in so far
she has telepathy so on and so forth and
that's cool but the thing to understand
about krakowa is that while crocoda is a
living island krakowic has feelers that
extend further Beyond really like kind
of in the surrounding areas and so what
this means is that if there's something
going on around them that only kokoa can
pick up say for example like a submarine
is headed their way that krakowa could
pick it up Agricola could in turn Alert
black Tom Cassidy or alert Cipher but
because black time Cassidy is kind of
connected to the island he would pick it
up at around the same time which is
exactly what happens here that when Jean
Gray says hey look there's some incoming
lifetime Cassie's responses I know like
we're going to check it out and see
what's going on now initially the mutant
population begins to panic right like
the people who are aware that
something's coming begin to freak out
and rightfully so because remember one
of the things that Hickman established
in the house and powers of X is that the
only way to get to or from kurkoa is to
pass through any one of the portals that
are available that are created by the
plants that are offered by krakowa the
only exception to this is the Marauders
of kitty pride and when people don't
initially know it's her they start to
freak out like oh my God somebody's on
their way over here now the reality is
you would expect that there wouldn't
really be anybody foolish enough to
attack rakoa head on right given the
sheer number of mutants that are there
but it's kind of a cool thing here
because it's like okay this is awesome
but then Gene rage heims and it says
there's something else aboard that boat
something filled with pain and what we
end up getting here is this realization
that on this boat is none other than
Colossus and this is awesome because
what's been going on here since the the
failed wedding more or less of Colossus
and kitty Pride where they didn't
actually get married what you ended up
getting was Colossus kind of falling off
the grid or at least that seeming to be
the case what he's been doing is
operating inside of Russia and
essentially helping to smuggle mutants
out and this is a really really cool
thing and the reason why is because
while we don't really see a whole lot of
that we only get small little Snippets
of stuff here and there it fits
perfectly in line with Colossus right
because he's not really a pacifist he's
not really a guy who's like I don't
really want to fight he's more like a
gentle giant but he's one of those guys
where like when it hits the fan you want
him on your side right his ostomia metal
skin makes him makes him almost
impervious to a variety of different
things right like most forms of weapons
out there he can't hurt it extreme
temperatures can either an extreme hot
or extreme cold of course Magneto
manipulating metal different things like
that can but also any kind of weapon
that can basically scramble or at least
manipulate metal itself like anti-anti
metal vibranium or like you know
anti-power weapons those things can kind
of scramble his powers thumb into
disarray and so on and so forth but it's
cool to see the Colossus is basically
making his return here the problem with
this is that Colossus experience going
through and basically working in this
kind of Underground Railroad so to speak
within Russia by basically helping to
smuggle mutants to freedom from their
from their captivity uh has taken like a
psychological and a physical toll on
Colossus right because it's one thing to
get out there and to say okay we're
gonna fight these various foes it's
another to see the kind of horrific and
inhumane experiments that they were
conducting on mutants in a means as a
means to like control their powers
possibly synthesize them different
things like that and it can screw
somebody up and so as a result of that
Colossus is in a pretty rough position
he's in a in a pretty bad place now what
you also end up having here this is
where this is where the plot really kind
of begins to come into play what you
have going on here is you basically have
a couple of people who basically get on
board a plane This Plane heading for
whatever destination it happens to be
but there's just two people who were
there they both look at each other and
they both recognize each other
indicating something as a foot who these
people are I will talk about here in a
second but what this also does is it
shows Charles Xavier heading towards you
know heading to sokovia which is a place
that on the the front server seems to be
in support of mutants but one of the
things that's being hit on here is that
for a lot of countries out there the
public eye is they support krakowa the
reality of the country is they're
starkly against them and so this seems
to be one of those instances a lot of
this really kind of seems to be because
of the fact that when Xavier's given a
drink there appears to be something in
it now we don't really know what that is
we're not really 100 sure what that is
but jumping back to this these two
people that got on board This Plane
suddenly like everything starts to kind
of go nuts right like the plane really
seems like it's it's hitting you know
extreme turbulence or they're losing
losing uh altitude but whatever the
circumstance of course the oxygen masks
come down and because oxygen Mass on
planes are designed to subdue passengers
as opposed to just allow you to breathe
that of course it knocks all the
passengers out right and so as a result
of that this is when this guy basically
kind of jumps up we end up finding out
the woman who was there has essentially
seized control of the cockpit and not
only that it's not just those two it's
two others and so they basically form
this entire team now here's why I think
this matters and here's why I think this
is so cool it's possible there could be
any number of people out there any
number of historically anti-mutant
groups right in the Friends of Humanity
who were Ultra conservatives the right
which were like these Ultra conservative
nationalists pro-humanity groups that
existed out there but I think and I
think it'd be really really awesome if
this turned out to be the purifiers I
think it would be amazing if like
William Striker is back again like
William Strikers here again and
basically implementing this and the
reason why that works is because
remember William Striker despite the
fact that he is more or less disgraced
still has a lot of resources at his
disposal and a lot of contacts that he
can tap into and so if that's true and
if it is William Striker and if it is
the purifiers this works awesome because
where you end up having like like Xavier
who's basically meeting with black Tom
Cassidy and talking to him you have Sage
who's kind of monitoring the whole thing
for those guys who are unfamiliar with
sage she's a mutant whose mind works
like a computer right so she never
forgets information and it categorizes
and stores things perfectly so she can
basically achieve perfect recollection
right like Perfect Memory recall it's
really cool how her powers work she
doesn't really have any offensive Powers
right no energy blast no super strength
or anything like that her mind is her
greatest weapon but it's why she's here
right because she's a huge asset for any
sort of mutant group that's basically
focusing on intelligence or needs an
intelligence side and so in the middle
of all this when Sage begins to realize
that it's not Domino when block Tom
Cassidy picks up on the same thing it's
you gotta go like you gotta get out of
here Xavier you gotta run through your
life because remember Xavier is the
heart and soul of this whole thing right
is the guy they have to keep alive now
it's not just because of the purpose he
serves insofar as being ah this kind of
guy alongside Magneto that basically
helped to kind of control what's going
on but it's also because he's he's a
kind of a moral figurehead if they lose
him it could demoralize a lot of the
mutants that are out there they would
immediately lose faith in the idea of
cocoa and they would say well if they
could get here and kill Xavier then like
Paterson Spode for the rest of us they
can kill us all so it's kind of a big
thing there but when these forces show
up when these four folks show up
Suddenly all hell begins to break loose
bullets are firing all over the place uh
black Tom Cassidy sends Xavier fleeing
for his life tells him like get to
Refuge hide underground and do whatever
he needs to do uh you have Wolverine who
basically flees and this is when things
get cool because black Tom Cassidy is
like you've come here to this living
Island right this thing is composed of
trees and plants and all manner of
things to oppose the mutant population
one of which who is me can control plant
life you've picked the worst possible
place to engage in any any battle
whatsoever and black Tom Cassidy for the
forces that oppose him he tears them to
Pieces rips these guys to pieces not
only that Beast jumps in and beasts
actually just like guts a guy and so
it's cool to kind of see that whole
thing go down right because it's
basically like these folks are showing
up here and it's the first real Attack
on krakowa it's the first real Attack on
this this entire Island this is straight
head-on physical altercation and so for
the most part A lot of these mutants
well I wouldn't say they're all falling
a lot of them are really being taken out
by these guys who are there and so
ultimately the Jean Gray and Beast and
and Wolverine end up tracking down
Xavier finally locating where he's at
only to get there just in time to see
him shot in the face to see Xavier
basically shot and killed and this is a
crazy situation right because your one
issue into this is like Xavier comes
back after the events of House of M
where he has the ability to walk and he
walks around for a long long time and he
does a whole bunch of cool stuff
everything all runs into Avengers vs
X-Men when like Cyclops kills him right
so then Xavier comes back during the
events of the man named X storyline and
now he's dead again right like he's dead
after that but here's the important
thing to understand here is that when
when it came to writing the X-Men
Jonathan Hickman didn't enter you about
this when it came to writing the X-Men
one of the biggest problems he thought
the X-Men had is that the entirety of
their Mythos for the last however long
was exceedingly dark and full of death
if there were characters out there half
of them had lost their powers or the
other half were dead and you couldn't do
anything with him but what Hickman did
not want to do was use death as a means
to like oh my God a character died you
know it was some kind of like story
seller right like the idea of death in
comics is supposed to serve the purpose
of continuing the story moving forward
and giving us a reason to care and so
that's why he invoked the idea of
mutants constantly being resurrected and
so all this would mean is that if Xavier
really has been shot in the face which
he has then all you have to do is
resurrect him but the cool thing about
this is that it's not designed for the
purpose of like we have to get you know
revenge on these guys or whatever
because they killed Xavier because he's
not dead instead this allows the story
to move forward in a direction of they
launched an attack on us we have to go
find out who it was that did this and
take them out that's what allows the
story to focus on it doesn't focus on
the death of Charles Xavier if dying in
the comics doesn't mean anything then in
turn it's the the one thing you're not
focused on if you know the characters
are always going to come back one you
don't have to worry about the item
they're gone forever two it's not a
gimmick and three it allows you to focus
on what the writer is actually doing
with the story instead of seeing the
death as this cheap desire to sell
Comics you know some kind of parlor
trick or something like that so I kind
of want to throw that out there I
thought it was a cool little interview
that Hickman did
okay so we are finally getting around to
covering fallen angels and we have a
very busy week this week we gotta play
ketchup right it was weekend the week of
Thanksgiving and we just did Thanos
imperative which you guys loved I had no
idea you guys were gonna love Thanos
imperative so much
if I'm being honest with you guys I was
like oh we'll go ahead and throw it out
there and just see what happens did you
guys loved it
which is always awesome to see it's
always awesome to see I can bring you
guys content that you dig but here's the
funny thing about Fallen Angels right I
was live streaming to a bunch of you
guys on Instagram and for those of you
guys who don't know I live stream to you
all directly on Instagram and like I
actually bring you guys into the
conversation so we have like one-on-one
conversations in front of everybody on
Instagram and one of you guys was asking
what I thought about fallen angels and
here's the thing Fallen Angels is a
great story but only if you care about
psylocke right if you don't really care
about psylocke specifically kind of like
the history of the character and really
Quantum more than anything else then
you're probably not gonna care but it
does have cable and it does have x23
along with a few other characters it
looks like it's gonna be pretty Beast
really like to be honest with like issue
number two it looks amazing but here's
the thing let's let's have this
discussion right let's explain the
character of quantum quantin
okay so psylock explained we did a video
on select explain like the full thing so
you guys can check that video down in
the description if you want the full on
like 30 minute explanation of our
character but but quanan was man
1980s and 1990s Comics okay so it played
out like this originally all you had was
Betsy Braddock right you had psylocke
basically the the sister of Brian
Braddock right she was just like this
British white chick and that was
basically it fast forward to Uncanny
X-Men number 256 right this comes off
the heels of a story called The Fall of
mutants and it was a way for Chris
Claremont to kind of reshuffle the
landscape once again by basically having
this great BQ set of events take place
we don't really need to get into it but
basically it led into the introduction
of The Siege perilous you guys may have
heard of that term before The Siege
perilous is actually a really cool
concept the idea is that if you pass
through it you essentially experience
Amnesia and you get to start your life
over and so what ended up happening is
psylock passed through it and then
watched the washed up on the shores of
the South China Sea the result of this
is that around that same time you had a
woman named quanen and quanen was
basically the lover of a rival faction
to her world right basically she worked
for a guy who was at war with the tribe
of a guy that she was in love with and
so when that whole thing when this huge
conflict ended up going down being
trained by the hand and all that kind of
stuff when this huge conflict ended up
being going uh ended up going down she
ended up having to basically make this
massive choice and the result was that
it basically led to her quote-unquote
death when she fell off a cliff what
this did is because she fell into the
water and basically wasn't able to
breathe and I kind of suppressed what
what little telepathic power she had I
basically left her in a catatonic State
and so what ended up happening is that
in an attempt to basically bring Quan
and back it was kind of a ruse by a
character named spiral she's not really
important she was part of Mojo's group
kind of this weird person out there and
like some alternate Dimension that tried
to treat the X-Men like a TV show
basically but the idea was that in order
to try to bring Quan and back what ended
up happening is spiral pulled a ruse and
basically the mind of Betsy Braddock was
put in the body of quantum and the mind
of quanen was put into the body of Betsy
and what this did is it basically split
their abilities in half and then gave
the other half the memories of the other
person right so Betsy Braddock was
walking around with half the memories of
quantum and Quantum was walking around
with half the memories of Betsy that's
why when you go into the post Uncanny
X-Men 256 landscape you have Betsy
Braddock who looks like a Japanese woman
because she's in the body of Juan
following that Quantum basically became
a character named revenge
r-e-v-a-c-i-a-n-c-h-e and basically like
she joined the X-Men for a little while
uh she was a henchman of matsuro who was
the guy that she worked for uh there
were a few other things going on here
and there but basically she was just
kind of there Marvel didn't know what to
do with her
literally you go read uh X-Men Volume 2
issue number 32 going forward oh really
issue number 23 going forward and like
they didn't know what to do with her
they were just kind of like she's there
and like she's kind of cyacked but kind
of not and like there were a couple
weird things that went on she died and
then eventually came back ultimately
Marvel cleared the air by essentially
having her quote unquote killed off with
the Legacy virus which was basically HIV
for mutants and then in turn where she
was resurrected and then basically uh
basically destroyed during the hunt for
Wolverine storyline the bodies were
eventually reversed back to the way they
were supposed to be right so Betsy
Braddock went back into her own mind and
her own body and Quantum basically went
back into her own mind and her own body
account it was it was kind of a long
running event right like it had taken a
little while to get to that point when
it was on its way but kind of finished
by the time you got to hunt for
Wolverine but essentially that's how you
end up where you are right now right
that's the reason why you see what looks
like psylocke and she's not actually
Betsy Braddock she's basically just
Quantum uh it's kind of setting things
back to the way they were before now
Juan and Betsy had met multiple times
right and the first time they met I want
to say they actually got into a fight
with each other uh but it was it was
kind of a cool little thing tomorrow is
trying to toy around with it right like
one was powerful enough that like Jean
Gray and Charles Xavier and like none of
the telepaths could differentiate
between the two Wolverine sent couldn't
pick up on a difference although
eventually it did it was kind of a weird
little thing but the reason why this
matters is because in the midst of all
this where you basically have Quan and
that's what we're going to refer to her
as uh we're gonna call her Quantum just
to kind of make sure that you guys
aren't really confused with you know by
calling her psylocke because that'll
throw people off but basically Quan is
just kind of going through a whole
telepathic process you know and and the
result of this is that basically she's
met by what appears to be the arrival of
this being called apoth right like apoth
is simply a being that's coming now the
cool thing about this is that this is a
wholly new character right and it's one
of the reasons why stories like Fallen
Angel is so cool is because what it does
is basically a fresh jumping on point
all you need to know is that at one
point along the line Betsy was in the
body of quantum Quantum was in the body
of Betsy and they're not anymore and
their own they're their own individual
characters the cool thing is that what
this is actually going to do at least
what I assume it's going to do is go
through a lot of the history of quantum
and give you the history of her
character because we didn't really know
a whole lot about her back when she
first showed up right like she was just
kind of there and we got these small
little tidbits here and there we didn't
really know a whole lot about what was
going on with her character she was just
kind of there and so it's kind of it's
going to be cool because it'll basically
go through and explore all these things
but with her being met by the Revelation
that this being apoth is coming the
first person she goes to is Magneto to
basically seek permission to leave the
island of krakowa now this is why the
current dawn of X event is so cool is
because everything ties together if you
read this by itself then you're like
well why can't she just leave right I
mean none of the mutants are forced to
be there so like why can't she just
leave but if you go and you read X-Force
none of them can leave because the
Island's on lockdown and the Island's on
lockdown because Charles Xavier was
killed no one gets in no one gets out
it's kind of a security measure more or
less that's why all these stories are
really cool because they all kind of mix
and coalesce together and create one
cohesive set of events but going to
Magneto and basically saying like I need
to leave this place like I need to get
out of here of course Magneto being part
of the Council of krakowa The Quiet
Council kind of one of the top members
can't officially say okay cool go ahead
and leave instead what he does is he
directs her to Mr Sinister this is a
very important thing the reason why is
because Mr Sinister lives up to his
namesake right he's a Sinister guy and
when the when he was brought on by like
Xavier and Magneto and so on and so
forth it was really one of those things
to be honest it was really one of those
things where it was kind of like it's
better to have the devil on your right
hand and know what he's doing than to
like let him roam free and have no clue
what's going on right so just keep him
close and keep an eye on but the idea
here is that with her basically
conversing with Sinister his response is
well I mean you should go talk to
Magneto but if he chose not to there's
different people you could converse with
and different people that you can
basically go to that will help you find
a way to get off the island right like I
can't necessarily tell you what to do or
I can't necessarily let you go the cool
thing about this is that he also kind of
toys with her a little bit because for
the most part sinister's only real
motivation this is an important thing to
understand here sinister's only real
motivation with anything he does is the
ability to gain freedom to experiment on
the genetics of various beings who are
out there to try to just create life or
just kind of pursue his own goals
whatever that you know whatever the case
is that's one of the things to
understand here is that while you do
have all these different members of The
Quiet Council while you do have Xavier
and you do have Magneto and you do have
Sinister then you have apocalypse and
all these different characters for the
most part they still have their own
goals and their own plans it's not like
everything they were doing before this
got put on the back burner and it's gone
forever more they're literally just
focusing on their own projects and some
of them are kind of doing it under the
radar with Sinister that's very much the
case and so what ends up happening here
is quantum basically goes and ends up
meeting with cable and x23 now there's a
particular reason why these were here if
you go back and you read the old Uncanny
X-Men stories with with Laura Kinney
which was really first introduced and
spent some time on the team she gained a
kind of rapport with Quantum and so far
as she loved the way that she fought she
loved her style different things like
that it's why if you go and you read
Laura Kinney's Comics the way she fights
the Way She Moves is very reminiscent of
the old Quantum fighting style you know
it's like a ninja different things like
that it really is it's really designed
to kind of follow in that mold and so as
a result of that well they weren't
necessarily like besties they were
certainly individuals who who really
helped the other become better the other
part of this is cable and Quantum
actually had a romantic relationship
with cable for a time during the whole
weird moment with their character kind
of being back but kind of not uh but
essentially she's worked with these guys
before like they were teammates on Rick
for mender's X-Force I think it was
maybe with somebody else's X-Force run
but on on one of the X-Force teams they
were teammates right now it wasn't
really this version of cable remember
this is the younger version of cable um
the the older version of cable was
killed off by this younger version but
it's all still the same person and so as
a result of that they basically end up
banding together and end up taking off
over to over to Tokyo now we are
introduced to a character named matako
and matako is is basically new here
right like she's a whole new character
brought in for this and that's one of
the things to remember is that a lot of
what we're going to be seeing here is
new she does say that like I'll do this
favor for you for old time's sake for
matsuo who of course was a character
this long since been dead the one that
originally killed Quantum when she
basically asked to die but the way this
plays out especially like give me
everything that's going on tell me
what's happening here and the funny
thing about this is that we don't really
get a lot of answers here it's really
like leaving more mystery and questions
than anything else insofar as there's
basically like in the beginning of the
story you had this chick that
essentially destroyed this train and the
idea was that there's this being called
apoth out there who's as much a concept
as a person it's kind of funky but it's
not like it's like apop is an idea but
apoth is also a person at the same time
who this mysterious person is we don't
know but what's really kicking all this
stuff off is something called overclock
now overclock is really the most is
really the latest iteration and various
external factors out there that can
essentially like enhance people's
abilities to a degree we've seen that
multiple times over the years right it's
basically what matako says is like you
know the destruction of this train the
coming of apoth is all really being done
by way of overclock and overclock is
essentially this device or this kind of
digital substance so to speak they can
basically like hype up the Endorphin
centers of the brain right so we've seen
that play out in a Litany of different
ways the most notable version that we've
seen is the mutant growth hormone right
that was what was used by Nitro during
the event in Stamford Connecticut which
saw him blow up the entire city and then
kicked off Marvel's original Civil War
event right so you also look at a drug
called Kick which basically amplifies
mutant Powers that's why Quentin choir
is so powerful different things along
those lines right so it's just really
the most recent iteration of this thing
the fact that it's digital means it's
easily attainable uh much easier than
something like MGH or something along
those lines but the the idea is that by
basically trying to trace down these
kind of directions you know we're a poth
is hiding from or hiding out or at least
where it's operating from or at the very
least like the various forms and and you
know I guess designs that it's using It
ultimately takes them to a place outside
of Tokyo Japan where you basically have
like all these these little kids who are
standing inside this giant room and then
they immediately kind of overdose so to
speak on overclock and all of them end
up going out now of course this
immediately starts to freak out Quantum
because the possibility of her getting
answers is all basically gone but one
kid is left standing an apoth speaks
directly through this kid and says like
my time is coming like as mutants like
go back to your eggs out go back to your
Island do not stay here like do not be
involved here do not be in this place
right because the world is going to
evolve I'm going to lead it to a better
future stay out of the way or die and
it's a it's a cool little ultimatum here
because it's a great little tease one of
the worst things that could have been
done in this story is if it had just
been like I am a poth and I am revealing
who I am and now there's no more mystery
or Intrigue or anything like that you
know that would kind of suck with a
story like this is designed to to Really
refuse to answer questions is really
what it's for it's designed to kind of
say hey so there's some things that are
going to be coming down the line it's
designed to pique your interest to drive
up your Intrigue and so it's kind of a
cool little thing here because what ends
up happening is ultimately you know with
this kid kind of delivering the message
of apoth and then dropping over dead in
turn once they get back to kirkoa Quan
and basically goes to x23 she goes the
Lord Kenny she goes to cable and says
get more people that can join our team
because like you guys as you as you
exist now you guys are basically weak
but I can make you strong and that's a
true statement right because remember
Quantum was essentially taught all of
her abilities by the hand and the idea
is that looking at pretty much all the
other X-Men and all the other various
characters who are here while Laura
Kinney is very capable she's unpolished
while cable himself is very capable he's
younger version of himself not the older
wiser experienced one and so with them
being brought under the wing of quantum
she will make them better she will make
them far more capable than they
currently are it's a huge assignment to
be given you know a huge task to really
undertake here but they'll be they'll be
all the stronger for it and given the
direction this story is going in they're
probably gonna need it
okay so we are picking up with X-Men
issue number two yes dawn of X oh god
dude I love dawn of X okay here's the
funny thing about this right this story
picks up with Cyclops walking in to
greet his children Rachel Summers and
cable now this is gonna this is gonna
blow your mind just to give you some
history on the complex nature of these
characters right just just to show you
how ridiculously complex the X-Men has
been over the years here's the origin of
these two kids right see if you can see
if you can follow this I want to see if
you can follow this so Rachel Summers
isn't even from this universe Rachel
Summers is from an alternate reality
which you guys know as Days of Future
Past and in this alternate reality
Cyclops and Jean Gray had a child but it
turned out to be Rachel as most of you
guys know the the assassination of
Senator Robert Kelly Moore McTaggart and
Charles Xavier jump started the Sentinel
program and Sentinels became essentially
self-aware and then conquered North
America as a result of that Rachel
Summers alongside Franklin Richards
Kitty Pride Magneto Colossus and
Wolverine and I think storm basically
orchestrated an escape that allowed
Rachel Summers to use her powers and
send the mind of kitty Pride into the
past Kitty Pride went back she stopped
the events of Days of Future Past from
happening which made the Days of Future
Past reality an alternate universe as a
result of that because it didn't change
Rachel Summers not knowing that it was
now an alternate universe basically went
into the past and then skipped over to
the main Marvel Universe where she's
been ever since so that's the origin of
her character cable just the origin of
cable it's an absolute mess okay so one
day after Jean Gray died during the
events of the dark Phoenix Saga you
ended up learning that she was basically
cloned by Mr Sinister and this Crohn's
name was Madeline Pryor and this was
done because of the fact that Sinister
believed that if Jean Gray and cyclops
ever had a child that child would be
insanely powerful because of the genes
of these two characters and So
eventually he sends Madeleine Pryor out
into the world Madeleine Pryor ends up
meeting uh Cyclops at a family reunion
the two of them hit it off they start
knocking boots nine months later she's
given birth to a kid Cyclops abandoned
him he actually ended up taking him
taking off on him because Jean Gray came
back and so he abandoned his wife in his
in his and his unborn child at the time
there is soldiers that eventually
Madeleine Pryor gave birth to Nathan
Summers and because of that the villain
apocalypse realizing how powerful cable
could be kidnapped him and then infected
him with a techno-organic virus so that
if cable was able to overcome it that he
would prove himself being you know prove
himself to be worthy Cyclops gather
together the Inhumans X-Force and the
X-Men they battled apocalypse they
basically managed to push him away and
then Rachel Summers who would jump to
the Future had basically become a member
of a group called The clanaskani Who was
opposed to apocalypse and basically said
give us your baby and then we'll take
him to the Future and we will
essentially try to try to cure him if we
can't then we'll clone him and we'll do
the next best thing and so as a result
of that they took baby Nathan to the
Future in the year 4080 they were not
able to cure him so they ended up
cloning him apocalypse broke in
realizing that Nathan Summers was now in
the future that he ruled and the result
was that they ended up kidnapping the
Clone instead of the actual baby Nathan
and so baby Nathan grew up to become the
character of cable who basically hung
out with clanaskani and then the Clone
ended up hanging out with apocalypse and
his name was Strife that's the origin of
cable that's how ridiculous the X-Men
have been over the years right these two
characters were these insanely complex
histories are just hanging out with
Cyclops
I thought you guys might find that
interesting but the funny thing about
this is that
on here is there a massive Island that
basically popped up about 100 miles off
the coast of krakowa and the question is
what's going on with this with this
island right like why is it there and so
as a result of that Cyclops is basically
Gathering Rachel Summers and cable in
order to do a recon mission now here's
the thing this is an insanely powerful
team that's one of the things to
understand here they're insanely
powerful right like cable isn't a mega
level mutant albeit the cable isn't
really as as powerful as he could be
because he has to use his telepathy and
telekinesis to keep the techno-organic
virus from consuming its body Rachel
Summers is an Omega Level telepath right
like she's insanely powerful and so
you're talking about two of the most
powerful mutants on the face of the
planet who are just going to do a recon
mission
imagine what it's like to be a dad like
hey well I'd like you guys to meet my
son cable and my my daughter Rachel
they're two of the most powerful mutants
on the face of the planet uh you know
just don't mess with them otherwise you
know they'll basically make you think
that you're a dog and you're gonna spend
the rest of your days barking at people
and probably locked in a mental
institution it's it's kind of nuts but
when they get to this island this this
island itself really kind of houses like
like this massive you know sort of
organism that seems to be coming from
the volcanic structure and so when they
immediately get out there and they
immediately start looking around and the
question they really have to ask here is
what's the purpose behind this like like
what is this thing the cool thing about
this is that as they make their way
through they start to find these signs
of life but they're more herbivores than
anything else right they find like a
giant cow and and so on and so forth so
there's nothing of any real threat here
until it's consumed by like this giant
snake looking thing that leads to like
all three of these guys basically like
annihilating it right you know Cyclops
using his optic beams and Rachel Summers
using her telepathy and telekinesis and
then cable firing off his big guns
but what it does is it basically jumps
over to this all-white character right
this character actually looks really
really cool crying like Black Tears
essentially and then conversing with
some individual that we can't see that's
either inside of like another portal or
something along those lines but on the
side of something else and he keeps
addressing it as mother but the idea is
that mother you know the mother of this
guy is is really telling him like what's
going on here like these these islands
are merging together what you have to do
is you have to find him you have to
locate him he's the one that will lead
you and he's the one that will basically
save everything and so it's really sort
of a weird theme because what we end up
learning is this kid is what's called a
Summoner now here's the funny thing
about this this is like Skyrim basically
right you have like a Summoner Miner and
you've got a Summoner Adept and you've
got a high Summoner in the sense that
like a Summoner minor can can summon
like lower things you know familiarism
so on and so forth and then as you get
higher and level they can summon more
and greater things because that's what
that's when the situation sort of begins
to pop off right because when it comes
to the character of Cable cable is very
much one of those shoot force uh shoot
first ask questions later kind of guys
right it's just kind of like all right
let's just sort of get to it and and go
from there now when this all-white guy
basically this Summoner shows up here
it's speaking in a language that none of
them understand and the funny thing is
that in reality they probably could have
grabbed Doug Ramsey they probably could
have grabbed Cipher but as we know from
the new Mutant story Cipher is all the
way out in Shia's face this is the
reason why we're covering each one of
these stories individually right because
they all tie into what the other one's
doing but they're all telling their own
stories plus it's really cool and
cohesive when you can just kind of do
them all individually and sort of call
it a day the real question becomes what
happens when they all start branching
off and doing their own thing and it
becomes this unruly mess which it
inevitably will because it's you know
comic books it's the nature of what they
do but this person but they can't really
understand the language of this guy and
it's sort of cool because this guy
doesn't come here as a villain it's not
as though he's he's kind of like a bad
guy who wants to tear things up or rip
things apart and that was that was
initially almost kind of the way that
Hitman played it was like this is a bad
guy this is one of the things to
understand about Jonathan Hickman is
that with this guy being a Summoner well
he's not overly powerful at the moment
the idea is that at some point along the
line he probably will be that's the way
Hickman does things right this character
showing up here is going to become
insanely important later on down the
line most likely orc is likely going to
join the roster of the X-Men most likely
that's what's going to be the case but
regardless Cable in His Infinite Wisdom
decides to hand off a gift to this guy
and this gift comes in the form of a
grenade
and it's kind of crazy here because it's
like you know I wanted to give him again
sure that we don't need any
of the grenade and so of course that
progresses exactly the way we would
think it would when it's kind of like
you tried to kill me right so like he
immediately starts to lose his mind not
really loses his mind but basically
starts summoning you know using his
abilities as a Summoner and starts like
you know introducing like these these
gigantic monsters now the idea behind
this is that they're able to he's able
to summon beings or summon monsters from
what's called other world or outer world
and the reason why that matters is
because it's very very much akin to like
Asgard like we've talked about that
before that in in every Universe in
Marvel Comics you have what are called
pocket dimensions and these are
dimensions that are astronomically small
right in the sense that like they're not
as big as universes they're just really
small spaces that you can't just walk to
usually you have to pass some kind of
dimensional barrier or have a portal
open in the case of Asgard the bifrost
is open which is basically a portal that
allows you to access uh access Asgard
but this place other world is the exact
same way the difference is that other
world exists outside of the Multiverse
right it's not confined to a singular
universe but the principle Still Remains
the Same and the overall gist here is
that what you end up having is this
Summoner basically bringing peace from
what Jonathan Hickman does describes as
the Lands Beyond Otherworld are
essentially like the wildlands and the
reason why this matters is because
Otherworld itself is a giant land mass
right there's different areas that are
there like you have King Arthur's
Camelot and so on and so forth but a lot
of the areas outside of that are
unexplored or unexplained by Marvel so
we don't really know what's there and
it's one of those things where Hickman
is just kind of saying like it's there's
wild stuff out there and basically this
Summoner can bring those things to this
location and then use them for whatever
it is that he wants to achieve right
like these wild and Fantastic Beasts
from out there so the reality is that
he's not summoning them from places that
we're familiar with he's just summoning
it from way out in other worlds they're
just kind of crazy beasts and monsters
and so on and so forth so in the middle
of this great big huge fight Rachel
Summers ends up using her telepathy and
what she does is communicate with this
guy directly and then of course that's
when everything ceases and the question
is why did you try to destroy me and
it's like well I didn't mean to destroy
you like I meant to give you a gift and
and you know I just kind of wanted to
show you that like Hey we're good guys
here like we're not really bad guys
which is a pretty important message to
communicate right like hey like please
don't kill us we're just here to be cool
like we don't want to cause problems or
anything like like that that's what's
kind of funny because the question is
asked by Scott Summers why is your
Island coming over to our Island and
that's when we really kind of hearken
back to the events of house and powers
of X and this is a Rocco that's what
this island is if you guys remember back
during the house and powers of X that
krakowa was originally one giant land
mass so you had arako which was one
Island and you had gracoa which is the
other and because of the fact that these
kind of demons or Monsters were sort of
rising up from the rift in between these
two places that with the scheming of
apocalypse and using its Four Horsemen
that ultimately these monsters and
demons were suppressed and the island
was essentially split and so those
horsemen of apocalypse would stay on a
Rocco and ensure those monsters and
demons would never show up again and and
that was kind of like the role they
would play they were sort of the Hidden
Horsemen that we didn't really know
about and so what this does is basically
say that like this island is now
returned the krakowa is not a fully it's
not a fully cohesive unit and it's
basically merged itself with arako it's
back to its back to its normal self but
because of the fact that all this is
based on the fact these islands were
split what it does is go exactly where
you expect it to in the sense that
you've got this guy just kind of out
there doing his own thing and sort of
analyzing this new location that he's in
have they never seen the surface world
before and he's met by the arrival of
apocalypse and apocalypse basically
speaks the exact same language as you
know and understands exactly what he's
saying and it's like you know I've never
met you before like who is your mother
like who was it that gave birth to you
to which he replies I was born by War I
was born by the horsemen War as it was
cool because what it means now is the
horsemen of procreating either kind of
keeping themselves going and propagating
and so on and so forth and so ultimately
it's really Hickory kind of setting the
stage for what comes next and so far as
this guy basically says the forces that
the horse from person to keep contained
are returning they're coming back and so
we're going to have to like martial
forces or what have you in order to
Stave these guys off now keep in mind
this was not an easy fight for
Apocalypse to win apocalypse and his
Horseman had to work in unison and put
on one heck of a fight in order to
achieve this the reason why I say that
matters and the reason why it is it's so
cool here is because knowing Jonathan
Hickman there'll be a pretty significant
battle that'll take place and when it
does we'll get to see the full totality
of apocalypse's powers put on display
which I am very excited about
okay so we are jumping back into
Excalibur and this story is actually
getting super good everything from dawn
of X is amazing and it's kind of crazy I
think this is the best the X-Men have
been in years and I mean like years I
would say probably since like the mid to
late 2000s like it's pretty awesome it's
pretty exciting but before we get into
that I got an email from a girl named
Sarah and and I apologize for for the
late for this this late bit Sarah up she
sent it to me over the week of
Thanksgiving and actually her
boyfriend's birthday was coming up
during that week and then of course I
ended up catching a cold and like the
beginning of December so I just uploaded
a whole bunch of videos that I already
had recorded so I'm finally getting
around to recording new stuff and Sarah
wanted me to give a shout out to her
boyfriend Trey he was a huge fan of
comics explained so Trey what's up happy
belated birthday I'm sorry for the late
response but I love hearing from you
guys if you guys want to send me emails
send me emails to Rob robertjeverson.com
I love hearing from you guys like I I
love hearing and like talking to you
guys I try to reply to emails as often
as I can if I don't answer your email
another really good place to get a hold
of me is over on Discord and you'll find
the link down in the description but I
love talking to you guys right like it's
awesome because you guys are amazing to
hang out with but we are picking back up
with Excalibur number two now here's the
thing about Excalibur right like this
this story it's super good but like the
first issue was super mysterious and
that kind of seems to be par for the
course of what's been going on with Dawn
of X we saw it really hardcore with
Fallen Angels which to a degree was kind
of a turn off but with regards to
Excalibur if you're into like the whole
Arthurian Legend it's good like it's
really really good this story initially
picks up with a couple of individuals
who are being watched by apocalypse and
it's kind of cool because apocalypse
really looks on them and says like these
two individuals well it really is almost
kind of a retcon right because what this
says is that apocalypse was the first of
the mutants right but it's a
misconception that he was like their
common ancestor meaning like they all do
all kind of came from him and and it's
interesting because it kind of Falls in
line with the history of mutants but
also changes it because the the
chronological timeline of the Newton
population is that you originally had
Celine who was the first mutant more or
less to pop up which is to say a person
with powers through genetic modification
occasion but after that you got
apocalypse and then you got a whole
bunch of other mutants along the way now
in terms of what's being said here this
is in continuity right apocalypse was
born but the the funny thing is that
apocalypse didn't know he was a mutant
when he was created like when he came
into existence he didn't find that out
until the 1800s right so if he was born
in the year 5000 it was was it like 6
800 years later that he basically found
out he was a mutant uh it wasn't until
he met Nathaniel Essex that was the case
but the funny thing is that that by this
point in time he's already reached that
point in his history so we can kind of
roll with that and just say okay this is
this is kind of cool but it's changing a
couple things up you know there was a
time in Marvel where originally mutants
were believed to have kind of ascended
from apocalypse like he was the first
and they kind of went from there that
was cleaned up quick fast and in a hurry
the old X Factor Comics kind of led us
to believe that by Walter and Louise
Simonson with all the decorations of
Apocalypse that he was the first mutant
all that kind of stuff when you get to
the adventures of of Cyclops and Phoenix
that all gets changed right it all gets
it all gets kind of removed and
everything but the idea to say that like
apocalypse was the first of his kind the
first mutant that's a big declaration
right because it leaves out Celine and
any other externals or mutants that
possibly came before apocalypse so it's
kind of a cool thing but with regards to
these two twins who were actually Druids
and we'll learn about them I'll explain
them once we get further into the story
because I feel like that's something a
lot of people want to know what are The
Druids like how does all that stuff work
ultimately the ability of these two
mutants who were in and of themselves
drew it but also had the ability to
essentially always know where they were
supposed to go uh because of their
powers much like apocalypse they were
cast out of their original tribe and the
result was that because they weren't
really seaworthy they ultimately ended
up drowning now apocalypse could have
stepped in and saved them but for those
of you guys who are familiar with this
character apocalypse believes in and
basically Darwinism right I guess really
social Darwinism Only the Strong deserve
to survive and so if they were incapable
of keeping themselves alive because they
didn't know how to Fashion a boat that's
on them and so because of that
apocalypse just kind of let them drown
and so it's pretty it's pretty hardcore
and it's pretty intense but we'll find
out why that little bit of an intro
matters here in a second but what it
does is it picks up with Betsy Braddock
the new Captain Britain alongside Rogue
of course who's in a catatonic state
after the first issue so if you're
unfamiliar with that go back and watch
our video along with the rest of
Excalibur right so Gambit Kitty pride
and and Jubilee and so the result of
this is that what they're doing is
they're actually traveling to uh to the
new Brian Braddock Lighthouse right the
new Lighthouse of Captain Britain now a
little bit of an explanation here right
because I don't want to just leave you
guys and be like they're traveling to
the Lighthouse Moving on I don't want to
just leave you guys hanging on this
right so when it comes to Captain
Britain as as we've talked about in
previous videos Captain Britain is a
multiversal entity right meaning to say
that like there's one Captain written in
every single Universe right it's a
multiversal course so imagine like the
Green Lantern from DC except there's one
Green Lantern for every universe and
that's basically what the Captain
Britain core is the idea is that the
lighthouse serves as as both the
headquarters of Captain Britain as well
as a means for him to access the
Multiverse essentially now originally
the Captain Britain Lighthouse existed
in Britain and that ran until about
Excalibur issue number 50 and that
coincided with the first real origin
story we got for the Phoenix But
ultimately the the lighthouse was
destroyed by Captain Britain's
girlfriend at the time Megan who
ultimately became his wife and the
result was that the new Lighthouse was
built in a different location education
and that's the location that they're
heading to right now it's not the most
important thing ever but when you're
reading through the comic and it's like
you know Kitty Pride makes a reference
to um yeah Kitty probably makes
reference to like you know I remember
the lighthouse you know we destroyed the
old one that kind of a thing that's what
she's referencing because Kitty Pride's
time on Excalibur and when the original
Lighthouse was destroyed oh it really
kind of came along with the with the the
fall of mutant storyline and the
aftermath with Kitty Pride you know
serving some time as part of the team
kind of off and on different things like
that but uh the overall gist is this is
that once you know as they're making
their way they basically come across
sealed people now deviating away from
the comic for a second the legend of the
seal people is actually really cool now
I'm not super familiar with it right I'm
not from Scotland uh but as I understand
it uh there's different variations of
the legend of the seal people but I
think the Scottish legend and somebody
like if you guys are watching this and
you're from Scotland feel free to
correct me down in the comments right
but I think the original Legend or the
legend as it goes in Scotland is that
when it comes to women who are seal
people that like uh like a surface
person like a human can steal their skin
and when that happens she becomes bonded
to him right she's always on the hunt
for her again but she basically kind of
essentially creates a life with him
right now she always Longs for the sea
and she's always looking to return to
the ocean and she will as soon as she
finds her skin now I think there's
different variations where it breaks
down from there there are some stories
where it says that like even if she
father or I'm sorry she has children
with him ah this she'll be she'll
basically like stay for the sake of the
children or come back and visit the
children but I think the traditional
story the traditional Legend is that if
she ever finds her skin she'll abandon
her life on the surface and go back to
the ocean but it's kind of an
interesting story right I love learning
about folklore stories from like other
countries but that's basically what's
kind of going on here is that they
basically start to attack not a great
big huge thing they're dealt with pretty
quickly and and what they end up doing
is basically crash landing on this rock
and then from there trying to navigate
and figure out where they're gonna go
but what they end up doing is stumbling
across Druids now Druids and Marvel
Comics it's kind of interesting here
because if I remember correctly and I'm
pretty I'd like to I'd like to think I'm
pretty knowledgeable about them The
Druids haven't really appeared that
frequently in Marvel except for like the
old name of the Submariner Comics right
and the involvement of The Druids back
then was the limit to like them
basically being tricked by by the
Germans into believing that like English
people like Britain uh the British were
like the bad guys right you know and the
result was that name of the Submariner
was eventually dispatched and he ended
up convincing The Druids like the
Germans were the bad guys and like The
Druids fought alongside the name of the
Submariner and defeated the defeated the
the Germans and that was it right but
The Druids don't really have a huge they
haven't had like a huge presence in
Marvel in a long time now my knowledge
on Excalibur is nowhere near my
knowledge on pretty much else some
everything else in Marvel Comics right
so um I wouldn't I wouldn't by any means
call myself an expert on this but The
Druids are an exceedingly secretive Clan
they're almost never really seen or
heard from in Marvel Comics now the
results of this is that one of The
Druids basically Taps into the mind of
Betsy Braddock and basically says like
what's going on here is this Lighthouse
that was here that you guys were coming
to it was destroyed by by basically the
academy right like the akaba coven is
essentially what they're called this led
by Marianna Stern now we talked about
the acaba coven in a previous video
because the clanic Haba grows part and
parcel with apocalypse himself and so
the question is if the clanocabul was
here albeit operating as a coven of
sorts then the question becomes how does
that involve apocalypse and our original
Theory our original philosophy was that
basically apocalypse had some kind of
scheme of his own on that was running on
the side and intended to manifest the
scheme and whatever it was going to be
now at the moment the coven acaba draws
their power from uh from Morgan Le Faye
right so they're not really working for
or empowered by apocalypse so the
question was like what does apocalypse
have to do with this and so the result
is that once you start to get through
this and once you start to really
investigate what's going on then things
get kind of crazy because what ends up
happening here is basically Betsy
Braddock essentially like along with The
Druids breathes back the the Lighthouse
of Captain Britain in the sense that The
Druids basically approach her and say
like we recognize your title we
recognize you as the current Captain
Britain the previous Captain Britain is
currently incapacitated we know that
with Brian Braddock basically being held
captive by Morgan lafaye out in other
words where like King Arthur and all
those guys reside and the result is that
they're just kind of operating and doing
their thing now the reason why this
matters and the reason why this is going
on is because what we know so far is is
that the Covenant Kappa is basically
operating to try to like stem the
Resurgence of the mutant population
right they're just one of many groups
out there this essentially you know kind
of opposing the expansion of Newton Khan
and so when kirkoa was creating all
these different Gates across the world
that would allow people to pass through
those Gates and enter cocoa which is
basically the home of mutants that they
were opposed by Morgan lafaye as well as
the the Covenant cabin because the coven
works for Morgan lafay they were kind of
her agents on Earth they were basically
trying to stem the tide and prevent this
uh sort of expansion of the mutant
population yet another group out there
that's basically doing that and that's
why these groups are at odds with each
other is because The Druids view the
coven as basically these external agents
they're basically bad guys and The
Druids themselves are good guys who are
trying to find some way to keep Britain
protected Now The Druids aren't really
working on behalf of the mutant
population and they don't really care
about the mutant population it's more of
them acting because everything that the
Covenant is doing is encroaching on the
territory of The Druids right so it's
like you know we're working on behalf of
mutants kind of but not really but only
because the coven is basically
encroached on our territory and they're
doing things that we don't like that's
really what it kind of boils down to and
so in the midst of all this apocalypse
this great big huge fight that goes on
with the coven and The Druids alongside
Betsy Braddock apocalypse basically
Chimes into Betsy Braddock and says tell
me what's going on and what Betsy
basically reveals is everything I just
said to you and that's when apocalypse
spills the beans and what he says is
that essentially the Covenant Cabo were
basically his agents at one point in
time they were individuals who worked
for him at one point in time they served
his own purpose the result was that he
basically rejected and abandoned them
and with that being the case they were
left leaderless and so ultimately they
ended up siding with Morgan lafay but
with Morgan lafay being someone who said
she doesn't want the mutant population
to expand beyond Earth and into the
realm of Otherworld she's basically
using the coven to keep that from
happening and that's why these groups
are essentially at odds with each other
that's why they're battling each other
and so that's why apocalypse was like
yes they were my henchmen I will step in
and I will stop them right because Betsy
Braddock isn't really able to do it on
her own Captain Britain's powerful but
not all-powerful right I mean he's just
like a really really capable character
and that's basically it so the craziest
thing happens apocalypse steps in in and
in one Fell Swoop the entire cavanacaba
is taken out in one Fell Swoop they're
all gone like just dunzo and it's kind
of crazy to see right like the power of
Apocalypse this is where I think
apocalypse really shines right when you
get these small little moments where
it's just like here's how powerful he
really is right it's not these grandiose
displays or great big huge you know
monologues or anything like that they're
cool but it's when like a force like
some superhero team like The Avengers
are struggling against or the X-Men are
struggling against an apocalypse has a
vested interest in seeing like the X-Men
of the Avengers succeed steps in on
their behalf done and just like takes
the enemy out like that it's just it's
cool to see it's an awesome thing to see
but what he basically says here is you
have to go to other world and you have
to save your brother Brian Braddock
because he's basically becoming more and
more of a henchman of Morgan lafaye by
every moment right the longer he stays
under her spell the more of his identity
begins to go away and so if you don't
save him soon you'll never have the
chance to do it again and so the result
of this is that you end up having Betsy
Braddock alongside Gambit and then
alongside Jubilee who's grabbed her kid
uh shogo and they basically end up
traveling into other worlds but when
they get there basically The Baby Show
Goes turned into like a giant dragon I
imagine things are gonna get kind of
Bonkers from here right like you guys
are probably gonna end up seeing a lot
of like legendary stuff here right it's
like dragons Sorcerers Wizardry
different things like that because
that's all other world stuff the story
is getting cool and I'm really really
digging it like I'm really really
enjoying it
okay we are picking up with the
Marauders Marauders issue number two
here's the thing I love Marauders like I
love what's going on with the Marauders
it's awesome and it's an absolute blast
like I'm glad to see they're kind of
doing that right like I'm glad to see
that each individual title as part of
dawn of X has its own kind of like tone
right like its own feel it's one of the
things that's very easy to mess up and
it's one of the things that's very easy
to lose right like when you launch a
title and they all feel the same well
like that was a problem with Marvel in
the 90s like everything in the 90s felt
the same
I mean some of it was kind of cool ah
but everything kind of felt the same and
so the cool thing about this is that
each one of the stories kind of had
their own little tone here their own
kind of system going on that when it
comes to this particular story what we
picked up with in the last video is that
basically a kitty Pride had formed her
own group right she was basically the
Marauders and just kind of going out and
the initial the initial plan there
really seemed for her to just kind of
figure out what the nature and function
of her team was now what this does is
kind of give us an answer to that and
basically tell us what's going forward
from there but the idea is that this
initially picks up really with a
conversation between Emma Frost and and
what looks like the stuff for Cuckoos
and initially he's just kind of like
okay like they basically decline her
offer and she makes reference to
something called the Lord Imperial now
the way this works here is remember
there's always kind of a hierarchy when
it comes to these different positions
within the various uh organizations that
exist out there right the only exception
of that is the the quiet Council right
the quiet counsel is kind of split up
into different different factions
different groups but each of them all
kind of have an equal power but they all
sort of run their own little area but
there's no kind of like overseer for it
all I guess you could argue that it's
more McTaggart but she seems really
hands off and we don't really know
exactly what all she's doing aside from
just simply seeming to kind of guide
people instead when it comes to this and
it's kind of a breakaway from tradition
the Hellfire Trading Company basically
has or at least what they're looking for
is a lord Imperial which oversees the
entire Hellfire Trading Company and
that's a breakaway from tradition
because remember the hellfire club has
historically been this organization that
for the most part uh the Inner Circle
wasn't really known by a lot of people
most people didn't know the Inner Circle
existed at all and for the most part the
Inner Circle will use this kind of
anonymity combined with its vast wealth
to basically influence global policy in
its favor right not really necessarily
dominate the world but to basically
amass a lot of money and power and
influence and so having like an
individual who will reside over all of
them is kind of intriguing here it's
it's it's pretty interesting to see what
direction that's going to take but you
know with with the stepper cuckoo
seemingly turning down this offer
presumably for for the Lord Imperial if
not for the position of the red king or
Red Queen then what it does is it
basically jumps over to Sebastian's Shaw
now remember the idea behind this is
that the Hellfire training company
operates in two fronts the first is a
front-facing aspect of it and the second
is the black market and the reason why
is because in order for Cocoa to
generate income it basically has to
provide a good or service that people
want to buy and that's why the idea of
krakowa kind of manufacturing these uh
these drugs or these substances they can
like add years onto your life or can
cure any kind of mental disease or
anything like that are being offered
right because it's basically kind of
like a pharmaceutical industry that's
being offered by mutants that just
crushes anything that's being offered by
you know any existing Major Market
that's out there right now right like no
pharmaceutical company author can
compete with what it is a KOA has and
it's why they're dominating the market
but what you have out there are
countries that by virtue of their
population will basically say yes we
support kakoa and we do want to take
part in the various drugs and things
they have that can improve the lives of
our citizens then you have those
countries who choose not to support them
now some countries choose not to support
cocoa because of the fact that like if
the leader of the country chose to the
people would revolt and they would
basically kill the leader and all the
people in power and put somebody in
there who doesn't support cocoa or
because the leader doesn't want to feel
like a dictator that rules their country
with an Iron Fist and they don't care
what the people want and so the idea
here is that for those countries that
basically support krakowa that's where
Emma Frost comes in right she basically
says okay we're gonna lead all these
different these different things to this
country we're going to give them that
are you know the various medicines and
supplies of cocoa which of course
they're going to pay for for the black
market aspect basically those countries
that for whatever reason cannot publicly
support kakoa but still want access to
all their medicines they can buy them
through the black market and Sebastian
Shaw is the one who's supposed to be
providing that what Sebastian Shaw has
been doing is actually deviating out of
his line he's been going to like
countries out there that basically
support cocoa and then providing them
with medical supplies or providing them
with the kind of things that kakoa can
offer kind of deviating out of his Lane
and so as a result of that kitty Pride
really at the moment seems to serve as a
kind of checks and balance right and
this instance it was basically like okay
things have kind of gone awry Kenny
Pride's team was sent in and they're
basically going to seize the ship of
Sebastian Shaw on the orders of Emma
Frost and it's one of these things where
it's kind of like stay in your lane do
what you're supposed to do otherwise
this is going to happen time and time
again and you need that right like you
need that kind of system in place if
there if it was just kind of like okay
so we're like the Hellfire training
company just go ahead and do whatever
you want to there'd be no order and no
structure and everything that exists in
krakowa in terms of the role the mutants
play the kind of things they provide and
how they more or less manipulate the
world markets is really done by
maintaining order and structure it has
to function that way otherwise
everything they've built on a financial
aspect comes crashing down and so what
this ends up doing is it actually ends
up picking up with the Boda Sebastian
Shaw which is actually being led by
batroc the leaper now backtrack the
leaper he was a cool guy AI well he was
an old school Captain America villain he
did um what was he I think it was a he
was a French kickboxer he was awesome
like it was fun to watch him his stories
where he would like fight Captain
America like it was fun to read those
comics from back in the day he didn't
really do those too much anymore but
that's the cool thing about this is that
kitty pride is kind of uh at least her
Marauders are kind of a Swiss army knife
so to speak for the mutant nation of
krakowa and so far as what they're doing
here is they're basically kind of
maintaining the the order of things and
so far as Sebastian Shaw or ensuring
Sebastian Shaw's vessels only go to
Black markets but then they're also
liberating mutants from countries that
won't let mutants leave in order to go
to krakora right so they're kind of
covering a bunch of different things but
what is up happening here is that once
Katie Pratt and all them finally get
onto the vessel itself they essentially
sink it
which is kind of a funny thing and
backtracking them can't really do a
whole lot to stop her I mean that's one
of the things that was established in
the previous issue of the Marauders is
Kitty Pride like running in and like
literally alone government right her
ability to phase through all kinds of
things basically makes her seemingly
Unstoppable but in turn like once the
ship has sunk they basically say hey
look here's my new vessel it's a great
big huge yacht it's like equipped with
weapons and all kinds of crazy stuff but
but basically what you're getting here
is kind of this pirate life now of
course Emma Frost basically Chimes into
Sebastian Sean says hey look so like we
basically sunk your ship so stay in your
lane and and don't deviate again
otherwise uh you're gonna get more of
the same and that's kind of the funny
thing is Sebastian Shaw can't really
stop it right I mean there's really
nothing he can do here because he's the
one that errored so he says like I want
to call together a meeting of the client
Council and basically they say okay
what's your case Sebastian it's like
well I've been deviating away from my
task instead of providing you know the
the things that we have the the goods
and services that we have to the black
market I've been going to like the
public markets which is what Emma Frost
is supposed to do but I've been doing it
instead and so basically we're doubling
up and we're not really serving them
black markets I'm not doing my job and
like she sent my because of it she
punished me for it and that's a problem
I mean how do you justify that right
like how do you make that case like I
wasn't doing my job and I was penalized
for it that's like the most entitled
attitude ever it's like if you're not
doing your job well then maybe we just
get somebody to replace you like
somebody who can do your job like it's
it's a funny little thing here but like
that's literally the spot that he's in
and this is the important thing to
understand about Emma Frost right the
way that she depicts this in this
conversation with with Sebastian Shaw
the way that she depicts this is this is
the way the game is going to be played
this is how it's going to function you
can play just like we tell you you could
do what we tell you to or we can replace
you with somebody who will Emma Frost
does not care and that's the coolest
thing about her characters Emma Frost
always kind of had this confidence this
kind of haughty hubris attitude of like
I can do what I want to and nobody can
get in my way right like there are there
are two kinds of people in this world
the ones that I can work with and the
ones who get in my way and if you get in
my way then I'll just have you spend the
rest of your life you're believing
you're a dog and just barking and
carrying them now following this Kitty
pride and her group basically travel to
Taipei and here's a cool thing about
this is why I love this so much they're
literally Pirates right like they do up
higher its thing right they're like okay
so like we're gonna travel to Taipei and
we're gonna meet with the person the
contact we're supposed to meet here and
then like once they end up realizing
it's Bishop Bishop's like your your job
is to stay here until you're told who it
is that you want to meet with and they
basically go into like a local tattoo
parlor and get tattoos and they go drink
it looks like the most fun ever dude I'd
be like dude this is gonna be awesome
it's like a party on the high seas but
here's the other thing to point here's
the other thing to bear in mind too is
this is Kitty Pride probably at her best
if I'm being honest as a person's been
reading as long as I have I think this
is Kitty Pride probably some of the best
writing for her character that I've seen
in a long time even like after all new
all different Marvel when she was leader
of the X-Men the problem is that during
that time the X-Men story sucked right
because Marvel was trying to tank the
X-Men in order to boost the Inhumans and
nobody wanted that everybody wanted the
X-Men and so kind of like giving us that
version of kitty pride in that
leadership role combined with like
amazing storytelling is awesome right
like she's got like this broken nose
with this bandage on her nose she's got
like this kind of flannel thing around
her neck she ends up stealing like this
cloak you know know and it's it's
amazing because she basically has like
these tattoos on her fingers that say
hold fast she looks like a pirate but
though ultimately they end up finding
out the person they're supposed to meet
is a guy named Gateway now Gateway is an
old school character right gateway's
been around oh God since like Uncanny
X-Men 229 and the idea behind this was
that Gateway was originally used by a
group called The reavers now the reavers
are some of you guys have probably heard
of before and they were basically kind
of like the cyborg faction that
basically like used Gateway who could
who could teleport people as a means to
like Loot and plunder he's just like
from Australia I think he's an aborigine
I'm not going to swear to that though
and like nothing's known about this
guy's past we don't even know what his
real name is right like all you know is
he's referred to as Gateway because
that's the name the reavers gave him
ultimately over the years he ended up
siding against the reavers joined the
X-Men and became a huge part of the team
for a long long time but he's there to
teleport them to where it is they're
supposed to go and then the the place
they're teleporting to is actually one
to this great big huge yacht this like
outfitted with like cannons and stuff
like that like it's literally this
multi-million dollar luxury yacht that's
been outfitted like retrofitted with
like all these weapons and different
things but the the other part of it is
that Emma Frost is basically removes
Sebastian Shaw's ability to determine
who the who's going to be the red king
or the Red Queen as part of the Trinity
more or less of the Hellfire Trading
Company now of course this pisses
Sebastian Shaw off to no end but at the
end of the day like he overplayed his
hand he thought he could basically kind
of get out there and do his own thing
sort of step outside the bounds that
have been created for him and ultimately
he's paying the price right that's
that's the price that gets paid for the
role for the role that he's played here
and so as a result of that what ends up
going on here is is basically like Emma
Frost is like well our our new red queen
is here and that's what he ended up
finding out that is Kitty pride and can
we all just admit the kitty Pride dress
as a pirate looks amazing
she looks amazing as a pirate dude it's
one of the coolest outfits I guess one
of the coolest versions of kitty Pride
that I've ever seen it looks straight
out of Pirates of the Caribbean right
like X-Men of the Caribbean it looks
awesome Jerry Dugan still got it man
like you go and you read stories like
Infinity Wars and it's like okay man
what was even going on and even like
with those Guardians of the Galaxy Run 2
degree it's like I'm not really feeling
it but like looking at his handling of
marauders dude Jerry Dugan's still got
it man like it's it's awesome
sorely missing out it's not even about
like crazy plot threads or anything like
that it's just good old-fashioned fun
and like you need a comic like that it's
part of dawn of X just a good
old-fashioned fun comic book to read now
I'm sure the plots will get more
complicated as time goes on and the
threats will become more significant but
like if they're gonna be invading like
showing up on the doorstep of countries
so to speak and basically saying like
we're gonna free mutants or they're
gonna be fighting off various forces the
high seas they're gonna need a vessel to
do it and having a multi-million dollar
yacht
outfitted with cannons it's basically
like a luxury battleship is awesome
so we're getting back into New Mutants
and New Mutants is the absolute best
thing coming out of Marvel Comics right
now and this is the craziest thing right
oh by the way for those of you guys who
want to see my uncensored videos and
those of you guys who actually want to
see videos I think the next one we're
doing is Superboy Prime versus Franklin
Richards and then I think after that
we're doing Superboy Prime versus
Matthew Malloy if you want to see the
versus videos head over to patreon right
the uncensored videos are like a dollar
a month and the versus videos are like
five bucks right so it's not like an arm
and a leg or anything it's pretty cool
stuff but New Mutants is amazing it's
it's absolutely Stellar so in the first
video that we did we had basically
talked about how the the New Mutants was
more or less being reformed with the
exception of Sam Guthrie right Sam
Guthrie was one of the original members
of the New Mutants and where the team
was being reformed they were actually
being reformed for the purpose of going
on a mission to see our space in order
to save Sam and bring him back and the
indication was that he was he was in
Jeopardy the issue with this is that
where they were able to book passage
with the star jambers of course led by
Corsair who's the father of Scott
Summers and the star Jammers are
basically space pirates more or less uh
what they ended up discovering is that
our Jammers actually intended to steal
an artifact and so the result was that
the the New Mutants got involved and
ultimately they were arrested for the
stealing of this artifact when
everything went South the stargamers
made off with it and then they were
taken before the court of the shiar now
here's the thing the court of the shiar
is intense right like Marvel's shown
this multiple times over the years
they're hardcore right like the lawyer
who's basically a Spate like a Marvel
Comics version of Better Call Saul is
basically what he is which is amazing
I'd love if you guys watch that show but
I love Saul Goodman and Breaking Bad and
Better Call Saul has always been solid
but the lawyer basically tries to plead
the case that like because the New
Mutants are from Earth they don't really
know Shia Customs or how anything works
there and so they should essentially be
pardon like he basically takes the guys
takes all of them and throws them before
the Court's mercy and the response of
the judge is like are we in Earth space
or are we in she our space and the
lawyers like we're in Shear space and
the Dutch is like that's what I thought
guilty
and it's like we don't care where
they're from they broke our laws and
that's just the way it's gonna go so
they're basically like this carries a
lifetime sentence you're going to be
handed over to the Shia officials and
they're going to decide what they want
to do for you only for us to find out
that they're being handed over to Sam
Guthrie and to Super Guardian the
Smasher Isabel Kane this is kind of
funny right because like we didn't
really know what was going on with Sam
Guthrie when he was out here apparently
he's doing pretty good for himself and
it kind of makes sense I don't know if
any of you guys know who super Guardian
is she was a character who was
introduced during Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers but basically
Isabel Kane is is really one of the very
few instances when I'm when I say few I
mean like you can count them on one hand
the very few instances where an
Earthling is actually inducted into the
CR Imperial Guard the shiar Imperial
Guard is basically this this Elite
fighting force composed of like the most
powerful or worthy beings throughout the
entirety of Shia space right so the
shiar only really brings in those who
were part of the shiar Empire going as
far as to bring somebody in from Earth
was actually a pretty big deal the
nature of Isabel Kane is she has what
are called exit specs I think is what
they're called but basically it's those
those red looking glasses she has when
she puts those on they give her the suit
that she has along with like super
strength with speed durability she can
fly through space without needing some
kind of an oxygen take it gives her all
the all the things that she needs she's
pretty capable and she's pretty dagged
on powerful she's a big time heavy
hitter during the events of time runs
out which basically had that eight month
gap between uh really when the
Multiverse was collapsing and like when
it all started to basically wind down
when the Multiverse was coming to an end
Sam Guthrie and Isabel Kane actually
ended up getting together they had a kid
together got married that kind of a
thing and they've basically been
together ever since right so that's why
you see the two of them together here
but it's kind of a cool little thing
right because like it's like this
basically this great big huge coming
together and the return of the New
Mutants and Sam Guthrie is just as goofy
as he ever was like how did you know we
were here uh he's like well I actually
planted tracking devices behind your
ears the reality was that the space
lawyer called him but but this is this
is cool right so for old school fans of
New Mutants it's a return to form and
that's what makes dawn of X so cool is
this like a return to the to the way
X-Men are supposed to be right like each
title is individual and each title feels
unique but it has its own style of
Storytelling is telling his own various
Adventures it's awesome right and this
feels like old school all New Mutants
right like the Hipster comic book fans
or the really old comic book fans will
probably attest to this like it feels
like Old School New Mutants and it works
right it's that great blend of comedy
and seriousness and so the result of
this is that with them basically being
handed over to Sam Guthrie and a super
Guardian the issue then comes into play
where super Guardian is contacted by
Gladiator now remember Gladiator is the
current ruler of the Shia Empire and
it's cool right because what he
basically says is the shiar Empire is in
need of your Aid you've all been
conscripted here's your mission go carry
it out now remember the nature of of the
shiar Empire especially under the rule
of uh of gladiator isn't really like
dark Like Gladiator is not a dick right
they feel like a terrible leader or
anything he's not like ruling with like
an iron fist but it's one of those
things where you don't disrespect the
throw and that was even the case with
with gladiator himself when he was
leader of the Imperial Guard like he
wouldn't defy the orders of the Emperor
or the empress but if they were orders
he disagreed with he would kind of try
to find a way to skirt them it was it
was an interesting little thing like I
believe the laundry was alive at the
time yeah launcher was alive during the
rise of Vulcan the third Summer's
brother uh when he started trying to
over like take over the shiar Empire and
so initially I believe that Vulcan
tasked Gladiator with executing lalondra
and instead he basically escorted her
out of Shear space got her out of there
and basically had her live in Exile
ultimately she died but had her live in
exile for a time or at least tried to
help her Escape so he was kind of like
skirting right like skirting the rules
more or less but the reason why they've
all been conscripted here is because
when super Guardian shows up when when
Isabel Kane shows up she's like all of
you guys are going to be serving on our
behalf all of you guys are going to be
working for us and here's the reason why
but before we get an explanation we end
up jumping to Gladiator who's meeting
with Zandra Zandra is basically the
daughter of uh LA landremani and Charles
Xavier with the two of them having a lot
of interest yeah I know Charles Xavier
is having kids all over the place man
it's nuts like for a guy who can't walk
he's having a whole lot of kids I don't
understand how that works it's kind of
nuts man Charles Xavier gets around but
zondra despite how young she looks she
is a host she is a force to be reckoned
with she's basically an Omega Level
character her power basically allows her
to tap into the minds of others and it
works on a universal scale right so like
anybody in the universe she can tap into
their mind and basically dominate their
mind Dominate and control them so
imagine Charles Xavier but like if he
could reach out to the universe it's
ridiculous how powerful she is like it's
one of those characters like Marvel
never really does anything with it's
nuts where her character resides but now
admittedly when I say Marvel never
really does anything with her a lot of
that's probably because of the fact that
she didn't really show up until Mr and
Mrs X number two I think it was in
October of 2018 so she's been around for
like a year right so like not long
enough to do anything with it so I guess
I'm kind of being a little overly harsh
on Marvel but it's kind of a cool thing
because what's really happening here and
this is a very easy thing to overlook
but is very important What's Happening
Here is the response of of gladiator is
the shiar Empire needs to have a
naramani on the throne meaning zondra
needs to become the new leader of the
shiar essentially with Alondra not being
there it's kind of starting to cycle all
over again right because she's a
spitting image of her mom and so it's
the cycle starting all over again that
anira mining is taking over the throne
Gladiator is stepping down his Magister
and going back to being the prey tour of
the Imperial Guard basically the leader
of the Imperial Guard it's returning the
shiar landscape back to the way it was
under Chris Claremont and it's a pretty
significant thing we end up finding out
the reason why this is the case is
because of the fact that basically
deathbird is trying to find a way to
make our way back to ruling the shiara
Empire desperate being the sister of
Alondra an exceedingly dangerous it's
cool if you don't really care about the
X-Men or the shiar then this doesn't
really matter to you it's just kind of
like all right I mean that's cool but if
you're like me dude that's awesome man
it's pretty sweet
so X-Force is the best thing coming out
of Marvel Comics right now because this
story is amazing dude I I God I love
exports it's it's absolutely amazing
okay so in X-Force number one we're
playing ketchup right like for those of
you guys who are following the the X-Men
playlist you're gonna kind of see like a
big content dump over the course of this
week kind of updating everything and
making sure that it's all in order for
the extra playlist I'm doing the reason
why I'm doing everything issue by issue
is to do it all in chronological order
right so that's why we kind of have to
play ketchup every once in a while in
case we miss something especially when
we take a break for a week so in the
first issue of the first video that we
did we basically had kind of like this
big moment where Charles Xavier was
killed right and Charles Xavier was
killed by these various forces who
managed to infiltrate the island of
krakowa now under normal circumstances
humans can't just walk into krakowa but
I mean I guess they kind of can they can
drop in from the air but the reason why
a lot of the initial attack was
dismissed is because while you had Sage
who's a mutant whose brain basically
works like a computer storing
information different things like that
because of the fact that Sage had
initially dismissed it because the
initial indication was that it was
basically Domino who was showing up what
we ended up finding out is that Domino's
skin had basically been grafted onto
these various individuals who in turn
infiltrated cocoa and then killed like
33 mutants right one of whom was Charles
Xavier now of course respawning in the
aftermath of it all with the shooting
going on all that kind of stuff the
X-Men really nullify the entire conflict
pretty fast I mean of course 33 mutants
were killed it was really more of a
surprise attack but with Charles Xavier
being one of them what this does is this
basically picks up with Magneto and it's
one of the coolest moments right because
Magneto really kind of looks at this
this is why I love Benjamin Percy
writing so much Magneto looks at this
and says if only I had been there I
could have stopped the bullet if only
you'd been made of metal then you know I
could have put you back together if only
if only and that's one of the coolest
things about this right because there
was a time when the death of Charles
Xavier well I would I would never go as
far as to say Magneto would never care
that Magneto probably wouldn't Shone
wouldn't have shown the same kind of
remorse right he would have basically
gone on a war path and attacked
everybody you know because of the fact
that Charles Xavier was was one of
really his closest friend and that's an
important thing to understand when it
comes to the relationship between child
Xavier and Magneto that yes they've been
enemies yes they've fought each other
constantly but there's a kind of respect
that runs there among the two of them
right the bond they share is is pretty
intense and so if somebody killed the
other then they'd be hell to pay and
that's really the the issue with Magneto
because he kind of has to hold back
right the initial desire of Magneto is
to make the world suffer right like
that's the initial desire of Magneto is
to make the world suffer here but the
response is we can't do that instead we
have to continue the charter of Charles
Xavier and that speaks mountains to The
evolutionary change of Magneto's
character insofar as again there was a
time when he would have said who cares
when Charles Xavier wanted everyone's
Gotta Die you know but now it's the
dream of Charles Xavier was to basically
turn their KOA into a place of Peace for
mutant kind and he would not have wanted
us to wage war on the world in response
to his death that's a huge thing for
Magneto to really sort of take on and to
adopt here and so the result of this is
that you have this conversation that
goes on between Magneto and Jean Gray
and basically you know Magneto's idea is
you have to find a way to resurrect
Xavier you have to bring him back but
should it fail and of course it's kind
of this going back and forth up it won't
fail it'll succeed that kind of a thing
now it's easy to look at this and to to
know that Charles Xavier is going to be
resurrected right to know he's going to
come back it's easy to look at that and
to say his death was all for naught but
this is the beauty of dawn of X as it's
being ran by Jonathan Hickman and being
written by everybody else Jonathan
Hickman's perception of death in comics
is that oftentimes it was used as like
shock value right like oh my God this
character died can you believe it
everybody go and buy this Comics you can
see you know that's really kind of how
I'd been treated in the years that
really came after the death of Superman
and so Hickman's stance was if that's
the case if people are used to
characters dying and coming back then
let's keep that Trend going but make the
death serve a purpose right don't use it
as like a shock value don't use it as
like some kind of throwaway plot device
use it to serve a bigger purpose here
and that's the reason why Charles Xavier
dying is significant is because it's not
the death of Xavier it's not like oh my
God Xavier died you know what I mean
you'll see a lot of like clickbait
articles from from news companies and
things like that who are like this blank
X-Men died you know or something like
that that's really them kind of holding
on to the way things used to be as
opposed to changing with the modern
times the reality of this is it's like
Charles Xavier dying is designed to
serve The Narrative of the story to
serve the purpose right so Xavier dying
is no different than if like you know
the X-Men had lost to battle or
something like that it's designed to
keep the story going and that's why I
think it's cool here because what you
end up getting is basically Jean Gray
and Hank McCoy traveling over to where
cerebro is now this is kind of a big
thing is because what Xavier had done is
he had basically taken cerebra which
historically had been used as a means to
basically Monitor and discover various
mutants around the world uh he had taken
it and used it as essentially a
computerized backup that what he had
done is is cerebro is constantly backing
up the various memories of all the X-Men
who were there and so when Domino was
believed to have been killed the last
memory she experienced would have been
backed up to cerebro but not only that
Xavier's final moments before he died
would have been backed up to cerebro so
what this means is they can resurrect
Xavier and he comes back just like he
was before he died it's a pretty genius
maneuver and it's a pretty genius thing
because the story continues on it's kind
of a question of can this actually be
successful can this actually work now
this is where things really begin to get
interesting is because what you do is
you pick up with sage and you pick up
with a few of the individuals who have
basically been captured by the X-Men
albeit they were dead at the time but
one of them is still alive and so
initially Wolverine wants to slaughter
this guy right and this is where
Wolverine is written incredibly well
right because Wolverine's pissed like
he's angry right about the fact that
Xavier died but more so than that the
fact that like humans would have such
hubris as to invade gracoa and launch an
attack when no attack was instigated by
the mutant population right it was one
of those we just won a place where we
can be we could be alone do our own
thing and be fine and then in turn like
Humanity attacked them anyway and so
initially Wolverine wants to kill this
guy but instead he kind of backs off and
he says get Jean Gray in here have her
scan this guy's mind before he dies
right because he's on his way to dying
find out who brought him here how all
this stuff works whatever the case is
and then when they ask well where are
you going Wolverine gives us very simple
answer I'm going hunting and that's what
I love about Wolverine right because
when he's written well and this is
that's the struggle of Marvel Comics
right the circle of Marvel Comics is to
write Wolverine in a compelling way when
he's written well I'll do Katie by the
door do his stories are amazing like
they're fantastic it's crazy when
Wolverine is written well he's one of
the most interesting characters in
Marvel Comics when he's written poorly
then you get most of the stories that
he's been in that's the last thing here
because what is up happening is with all
the information that had been basically
dumped to him by Jean Gray he ends up
traveling to Seoul South Korea and when
he gets there of course he's doing his
best to kind of break through and figure
out how these guys got on the plane and
where they came from or at least you
know how to sort of backtrack their uh
their information and so on and for the
most part it doesn't work right because
Wolverine's not tech savvy but then he's
met by the arrival of Quentin choir now
let me tell you something man
do print inquire dude I love pretty
quiet Quentin choir is a ridiculously
powerful character right he's he's an
Omega Level telepath this kid is not to
be travel with but more so than that you
know what makes quitting choir so good
dude he just doesn't care he's just like
so there's my way of doing things and
then there's the wrong way the kid
single-handedly let her revolt against
the entirety of the mutant like the
entirety of like the Charles Xavier
School dude it was one of the coolest
things ever there was this amazing
moment when he's uh was he's coming down
the stairs and Wolverine tries to stop
him and he just like totally screws up
Wolverine's mind and sends him through
like this insane maze in his own head
and Wolverine's just like sitting there
totally incapacitated oh it's amazing I
love the Revolt of Clinton choir but
Clinton choir was very similar to
Magneto insofar as he believed that
mutants were Superior to humans right
like mutants are better than humans and
we should rule accordingly right he very
much followed in Magneto's Footsteps in
terms of like classic Magneto wanting to
basically dominate humanity and then
turn mutants into like the superior
rulers of Earth and so it's kind of a
funny thing because what he basically
says here is like you're incompetent
when it comes to computers Wolverine so
basically everything you were trying to
do I've already done like I've traced
everything back I know exactly where
these guys came from and I also made a
credit card in your name and then ran
off the bill
why because Clinton choir is kind of a
dick and it's funny
and so what you end up getting here is
basically them you know traveling to a
location out just outside of Seoul which
is basically it looks like a giant place
where there's like newspapers being
printed and different things like that
you know some kind of giant printing
location when they get in there what
they end up finding out is everything
but newspapers is being printed here
what's happening is some organization
out there is basically manufacturing
assassins now they're not manufacturing
assassins insofar as brainwashing humans
what they're doing or at least what it
appears they're doing is engineering
beings so they can serve as the perfect
assassins biologically engineered to
kill mutants and so it's kind of a kind
of a nut situation because what you end
up getting is is basically like Quentin
choir and Wolverine in this building and
suddenly these biologically engineered
humans start attacking now this really
kind of draws out a couple different
conclusions right we can say that they
were in effect activated by some third
party or if that third party is unaware
they activate based on the presence of
mutants meaning they basically have the
ability to home in on those individuals
who have mutant powers and those who
don't that's really more of a principle
of nimrod right Nimrod was of course the
ultimate Sentinel who could actually
detect a mutant's power and a mutant's
weakness and then capitalize on that
weakness right whether it was a phobia
or whatever the case happened to be he
could use that weakness against them and
then dominate them and ultimately
destroy them right that's one of the
reasons why Nimrod was so capable as
like the ultimate Sentinel machine and
the other thing here is there are
basically mutant power dampeners in this
building meaning the powers of Clinton
choir don't work now this also means the
powers of Wolverine don't work insofar
as his healing Factor so if Wolverine
starts sustaining injuries until he
leaves the presence of this uh of this
mutant dampening field his powers won't
work and that's kind of an important
thing to keep in mind and it's actually
a little bit of a big Revelation here
right like putting Wolverine into place
it's actually one of the cool little
ways to kill Wolverine so long as he
stays in the location where his mutant
powers are damaged now of course that's
basically what the muramasa blade does
and nullifies the power of the healing
factor of Wolverine entirely but it's
one of these cool little segments that's
kind of thrown in there that's sort of a
throwaway instance where like you could
kill Wolverine it's a cool little thing
so what wolverine does is he basically
draws a conclusion and he tells quit
inquire if there is mutant dampening
here then it means that what they're
trying to do is hide someone they're
trying to hide like a mutant here and
keep them from using their powers and if
that's the case you have to find who
that mutant is most likely they're
hiding Domino here and of course when
quit inquire turns a corner he finds
Domino all basically sitting in this
stasis tank with half her skin missing
which is pretty screwed up but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end
okay so we are continuing our coverage
on dawn of X and we are covering Fallen
Angels you know after I covered issue
number one initially I was on the fence
I was like I don't know how I feel about
issue number one but my rule when it
comes to Comics is read the first story
arc and if after the first story arc it
doesn't really resonate with me then
I'll drop it right so I'm like okay we
got to keep on keeping on I'm glad I did
because Fallen Angels is awesome the
biggest problem with the first issue is
it doesn't explain anything things are
happening and that's basically it this
one is is awesome it's like one of the
coolest one of the one of the coolest
stories from from dawn of X right so
like the best thing coming out of Marvel
right now so what this does is this
jumps back into the past right and it
basically deals with it with a guy by
the name of Yama who's having a
conversation with quanen but the idea is
that she's having this conversation with
this guy you know this guy Yama and he
basically says I've met you before the
blade of of mjorin uh matsuo's prize now
it's one of the things we talked about
and and really in like psylocke explain
and things like that is that for the
character of Quan and she's been a lot
of her life or at least what little that
we knew and a very precarious situation
what you had is you had nion who was a
crime loose I think that's how you
pronounce it who is a crime Lord in uh
in Japan and then you had matsuo who's
the guy that she was that Quantum was in
love with who was basically an assassin
for the hand and the result of this is a
matsuo and Quan and knew that eventually
the hand and nion would basically end up
going to war with each other right
because those guys who were unfamiliar
the hand is a very very old and ancient
organization and those organizations
that come into conflict with the hand
are dealt with harshly and swiftly the
hand doesn't screw around and so because
my own was doing his whole thing where
he was basically encroaching on the
territory and the wall of the hand the
two tribes ultimately went to war with
each other and when they did matsuo and
quanen were caught in the middle and so
because they were lovers they were
essentially forced to fight each other
to the death Quan and her Allegiance was
it was for the most part explicitly to
her warlord and then matsuo of course
was an agent of the hand and so as a
result of that during that fight between
the two of them Quan and basically fell
off a cliff and and ultimately she was
believed to have been dead and around
that exact same time Betsy Braddock
washed up on the shore and that's when
you basically end up getting the body
swapped between these two characters
this this takes placed seemingly long
before that or at some point shortly
after that but the long and short of
this is that what she basically tells
this doctor is like close your eyes
right because what he's trying to do is
barter passage and get away and the
funny thing about this is he says
there's nobody keeping me here I just
need to get out of this place and I need
to escape and so she simply says cover
your eyes and then she kind of goes
through this really really amazing line
where she's like There Is No Escape for
people like us when we're brought into
the clan we serve the clan and that's
the way it is we serve until the day we
die and that's exactly what's what's
kind of going on here is this guy is
trying to defect he's trying to get away
and the result is that he can't right
Quantum kind of serving out her role
basically ends up killing this guy and
so you get this really really amazing
moment here and we're gonna kind of jump
forward sort of past this for a second
but we get this really amazing moment
where uh we're really in like right now
in Japan she ends up catching up with
essentially the wife of this guy now
basically she ends up uh ends up you
know taking out this driver and then you
know killing the guy and then basically
catches up to to this woman and says
look like I'm supposed to kill you right
I killed your husband because that's
what I was assigned to do but I'm going
to spare your life and in reality this
is a big No-No right this is a big No-No
when the hand tasks you with killing
someone one you kill someone the Masters
are the ones who decide who gets to live
and who gets to die you're basically an
object to be used to carry out a
particular purpose right under any
normal circumstance this woman and her
unborn baby would be gone baby snuffed
out and that would be the end of them
the reason why Quantum doesn't do it is
because what she says is like I reach
into the mind of your husband and I
realize how much he loved you and
basically when her husband was was
essentially saying there's no one
keeping me here you know there's nothing
going on it wasn't for the sake of
abandoning his wife and child right that
was not really the case it was to keep
them protected because as an agent of
the hand if as far as the hand is
concerned this guy has no nothing else
keeping him here they would have no
reason to look for a wife and child but
because of the hand because of the fact
that the hand eventually learned about
it you know of course hence the reason
why Quantum was sent after this woman
ultimately Juan was tasked with killing
this woman and so as a result of this
what Quantum basically tells us is that
eventually they catch up to her and they
kill her they will they torture her for
information then they kill her right so
it's it's one of these things where like
her fate was sealed the funny thing
about this is that quantity kind of been
keeping tabs on it you know she
basically experienced This Woman's last
moments when she was being eliminated
and she never ratted her out she never
ever ratted out Quantum and said like
that's the woman who basically saved me
that never happened right so that's an
insane amount of Allegiance and a huge
amount of loyalty and a massive thank
you you know for for these actions and
so it's a pretty big deal there but what
I want to do here is I want to kind of
continue this and I want to jump
directly over to a conversation between
Quantum and Laura Kinney with x23 and
this is probably one of the coolest
conversations ever right because when it
comes to Laura Kinney as long as she's
been in Marvel Comics right when Craig
Kyle and Chris yoss originally created
her in X-Men evolution then she was
rolled over into the comics with
jokasada's really weird NYX story and
then from there just kind of got rolled
over into her own origin and went
forward from there there was a lot of
Storytelling I mean her origin was
fleshed out you know her role how she
related to Wolverine things like that a
lot of that stuff was dealt with but one
of the big things that wasn't really
dealt with there is did she ever really
find a way to reconcile her rage right
the kind of thing she inherited both by
virtue of her training as well as just
the genealogy of Wolverine right you
guys know that Wolverine goes in like a
Berserker rage and all hell breaks loose
the question was did she ever really
find a way to cope with that and the
answer to the question is no and that's
why she's talking you're basically
working with Quan in here is because her
question is understanding you the way
that I do the connection that we share
here you have the same kind of raise
that I do but you keep it so under
control the question is can you teach me
to be the same thing and the responsive
quantity is yes I can teach you that I
can make you a master of your rage but
understand every Master is a slave and
initially Laura Kitty doesn't grasp that
the reality of what Quantum is telling
her is yes I can make you a master of
your rage but at the end of the day
you're still a slave to it because what
you're going to be doing is you're going
to be going about every single moment of
every single aspect of your life and
you're going to be working to keep it
under control right the fact that you
have this thing out there that you're
working to control means that it
dominates your life because if you let
it go out of control who knows what
might happen right so you're doing what
you're doing not because it's a thing
you want to master but because you're
scared of them because you're scared of
what would happen if you didn't Master
it in the effect that it would have in
your life it's a very profound statement
to make right it's a very profound case
to make the other cool thing about this
is that you basically end up getting
cable talking directly with Quan and
herself now again this is one of the
things we kind of talked about before
that when it came to the older version
of cable he was considered to be old hat
he was really really cool when he first
popped up the issue is that over the
years and Mom Marvel he's basically
turned into a plot device like there'll
be some event that'll take place and the
cable pops up don't do that you'll mess
up the future you know and that's
basically how his character ended up
evolving over the years that's basically
what he became if there was something
that Marvel wanted to fix or undo then
you know suddenly Here Comes cable from
the future I'm doing it because it'll
mess with your you know and and his
character really lost his purpose and so
because that is part of this great big
huge paradigm shift that Marvel's been
implementing over the course of the last
year or so maybe the last two years what
you ended up getting was the younger
version of cable from the future killing
his future version right so like cable
in 2050 years in the future versus cable
at 3 000 years of the future more or
less it was basically killing off that
old version what you're noticing with
this younger version here is he doesn't
really manipulate time in the same
fashion but he's not using time as a
scapegoat as a means to to get out of
situations and things like that he's
really kind of here and then carrying
out his mission accordingly right so
what knowledge of the future he has is
used in his stories but it's not
heavy-handed and it's not a plot device
it's a genius way to use this character
and so as a result of that what he
basically ends up saying is that as far
as he's aware you know kind of again
using the side plot this creation of of
overclock that there is a place out
there in Brazil that uses slave labor
right uses young young kids uses adults
you know this entire Village essentially
as a means to kind of continue the
creation of this product and the idea is
is using Cable's information we can go
out there and we can stop that now
here's the big issue that goes on here
is overclock is basically a product
being manufactured and being used or at
least being sent out there under the
World by apoth we don't really know who
hate uh who apoth is but one of the
points that Quantum makes here is we
can't just go out there and save this
Village we can't really save them
because every time we leave we riskoa
refusing to let us back in I remember
ever since the events of of X-Force
number three when you basically had the
quote unquote death of Xavier the island
has for the most part been on lockdown
and so leaving and coming back and
leaving and coming back at the end of
the day crocola doesn't really know what
they're doing when they go out there
especially when there's being extremely
secretive and so as far as krakowa knows
they could have been the ones who set up
the whole death of Charles Xavier now
they weren't but it could have been that
was like well maybe you did so like you
can't get back into the island anymore
until we settle until we get all this
ocean because of that it's one of these
things where it's like the next time we
go out we have to go out knowing who
knowing where apoth is and knowing what
he's doing we can't just go out
willy-nilly and so as a result of that
cable kind of takes it as an affront and
the reason why this matters is because
in this future the cable was raised up
and he of course knows about the notion
of like the survival of the fittest
right it was a very harsh environment
very difficult for people to grow up in
but he also knows a lot of history there
and he's seen mutants constantly being
used for for nefarious purposes and
falling in line with the charter of
cocoa and saying that we want this
island to be a safe haven for people if
only for that purpose if no other reason
then like we have to go out there and
help people where we can because cable
is a legitimate good guy at the end of
the day the response of quantum is I'm
not going out there and neither are you
and so the responsive cable is well then
fine I'll go out there on my own right
I'll go out there on my own and I'll do
my own thing of course he ends up taking
x23 with him and so what you end up
getting here is this really cool
explanation that takes place between Mr
Sinister and Quan and herself and what
is up going on here is that Quantum
really reveals the nature of like the
butterflies right for those of you guys
who are familiar with uh with Betsy Brad
if you guys know that whenever she uses
least back in the Chris Claremont days
when she used her psychic powers or her
uh telepathic Powers a butterfly would
basically appear on her face and so as a
result of that when Betsy Braddock and
Quantum went through their whole thing
Quantum used the butterfly as well and
one of the things that's kind of
established here is that she hated that
she hated the idea that it was really
kind of a holdover from when she was
being controlled or at least you know
when she was going through the body swap
with with Betsy Braddock and herself and
so what she still maintain that at the
end of the day she wanted to kind of
create that and make it her own identity
make it into something that was unique
and interesting for her as opposed to
kind of like this is a reminder of when
I shared bodies with with Betsy Braddock
and so that's what she's really been
trying to do in a lot of different ways
now it's not a huge plot point but it is
a way to kind of expand on the character
of quantum and focus on the little
elements about her because remember for
like 99 of the X-Men readership right
now she's pretty obscure they don't
really know anything about her right I
mean some people do but like you would
have had to have been reading Marvel
Comics really since like the late 80s
and the early 90s to really understand
the nature and the notion behind like
revenge and like everything that went
into her character and so as a result of
that it's one of these cool things
because sinister's response is okay if
that's the case and you're trying to do
your own thing then sure like you have
my allegiance now now understand this
the allegiance and the Loyalty of
sinister always comes at a price he has
some kind of plan that he wants to
implement and using juanin for his own
ends will basically help him achieve
that plan so that's really what's going
on with him the result of this is that
ultimately it ends up being Quantum
who's basically trying to reform herself
and not really so much as a hero and
this is kind of a cool thing because
what she says is like Betsy Braddock is
a hero I'm trying to be something else
what I think she's really trying to be
is I think she's trying to be a realist
right like when it comes to like
superheroes in Marvel yes they have a
real world perception of the world
rather yes you know Captain America is
not oblivious to the way the world works
right he's it's not like he's like the
only villains out there are people who
are just like robbing banks you know and
like whatever villains we're facing for
the week like Captain America is aware
of the fact that there's like muggings
and robberies that happen every day but
the overall gist behind a lot of these
characters is they're out there in in
like the big world fighting the big
fights right so like you don't really
see stories where like Captain America
is fighting some mugger who is like
attacking some old woman you don't
really see that and it really kind of
ties under the nature of quantum because
when she looks at the camera murder
Betsy Braddock is this is the girl with
her head in the clouds right this is a
girl up there out there doing whatever
superhero thing she's doing but she's
not really connected to the real world
she doesn't really know how dark this
world could be and so it's almost one of
these things where Quan is kind of
trying to become this kind of anti-hero
Slash hero almost kind of like this
wolverine-esque Punisher type character
we're not 100 sure yet but it's cool
right to see the world for what it
really is as opposed to how people would
like it to be is a very important thing
because what it does is it allows you to
see the reality of the situation as
opposed to walking around with
rose-colored glasses and so the result
of this is that of course her basically
teaming up with uh with cable and with
x23 going out to help save this Village
as soon as I get out there the village
is basically empty and they're met with
like this giant machine basically you
know this thing that that initially goes
to attack him and then of course the
story basically cuts off there but for
those of you guys who watch the first
video I want to know what you guys think
about this story so far right or who
read the first issue I want to know what
you all think about like issue number
two versus issue number one because I
definitely think it gets a whole lot
interesting
all right members of the Rob Corps uh we
officially have a Discord yes we do we
have a Discord server check the link
down in the description the link has no
expiration date and it's an unlimited
number of uses so you can use it as many
times as you want you can share it give
it to other people all that kind of
stuff I do have a poster on Twitter I
made a post on my personal Instagram at
I am Rob Jefferson yeah so go check it
out there's all kinds of stuff there
there's basically a gaming section A
miscellaneous section which is like new
comic spoilers things like that you can
self-promote your own channel you can
promote your own artwork you can discuss
the versus videos that I do on patreon
uh for those of you guys who don't know
I do versus videos that I put um
exclusively on patreon for Patron only
content and then there's like an anime
and manga section there is an indie
comic section for those of you guys who
like Indie Comics there's a DC
discussion section A Marvel discussion
section film and TV video requests in
case you guys want like a character
explanation that's done or a story that
you want me to explain all kinds of cool
stuff right like there's all kinds of
cool things for the Patriot uh patrons
there's a section there just for you
right so if you're on patreon uh head
over there and and basically sign up
using patreon and then you can
essentially connect your patreon to 2
Discord and see that the patreon patreon
only section but yeah it's cool like I
really dig it Brad I love talking to you
guys all the time uh right now there's
about a thousand people that are part of
the Discord already so it's pretty cool
like it's it's pretty awesome like it's
really been blowing up recently but yeah
so we are getting into uh X-Men issue
number three by Jonathan Hickman now
remember when we first started house and
powers of X and I told you guys that
occasionally there would be stories
where you would find yourself asking the
question but like what's the point of
this though
this is one of those but here's the
thing to understand is is the same thing
that I told you guys everything that
Jonathan Hickman does serves a purpose
he never really writes anything in a
story that doesn't serve any useful
purpose whatsoever that character will
become important in some form or fashion
later on down the line and that's
exactly what's going on here here's the
funny thing about this though is this
story initially picks up in the Savage
land now I didn't even know the Savage
land was being used anymore I thought
Marvel had discarded this essentially
after like Marvel Now 2.0 or whatever it
was and they were just like who cares
about the Savage lamp The Savage land is
this land mass in Antarctica that houses
was basically like a lush jungle right
and you've got all kinds of like like
not really monsters but you've got like
dinosaurs things like that in there
species that were thought to have been
extinct um and it's been home to a lot
of different places to Kevin plunder
also known as khazar two Magneto at one
point he actually served I used it as a
base of operations but it's it's kind of
like this this place is essentially
hidden away from the world and not a lot
of people know about it the general
public doesn't really know about it
originally The Savage land was this old
Marvel Mystery Comics concept from 1941
and X-Men Issue Number 10 Stanley and
Jack Kirby basically updated it when
they brought in Kazar and then it became
more of like an X-Men concept and then
in Fantastic Four number 316 Steve
inglehart came along and basically said
that like the beyonders were the ones
who basically got a hold of some race
that existed in the in the main Marvel
Universe and had them create the Savage
land right so there's a lot of history
there in terms of how it came into
existence and the purpose that it serves
but at the moment right now it's being
used by the X-Men as a means to grow the
various flowers and so on that are being
used as part of their black market and
public Trading Company right the
hellfire club Trading Company and like
so many times that we've seen before
some group manages to break through one
of the uh one of the the gateways of
krakowa and then access the Savage line
here's the thing the X-Men's Gateway
system is like the least secure thing
ever with a number of people who have
managed to gain access to the X-Men's
krakowan Gateway system it's like a
person who's got like a door that sits
open with just a sign just sitting on
like a pole in front of the door that
says please do not enter my home of
course people are gonna go in and to and
see what you have like if they're if
they're interested in stealing your
stuff you've got no real security
measure and that's basically what this
is right so of course as soon as I get
in there they immediately spray down
like pixie and a couple others and and
essentially you know just kind of like
neutralize their powers and that's
basically it so what this does is it
immediately leads into the Gathering of
the quiet Council and the reason for
that is because one the gateway to the
Savage land has basically been cut off
meaning nobody can get in or out of the
Gateway and two there's actually an
after effect as a result of this that by
whatever Manner and whatever means this
group that's broken in has managed to
find some way to basically influence
krakowa itself and so far that kokoa has
essentially shrunk down inside by like
0.0001 percent like 158 square feet
basically so it's not like a huge
decrease in size but it is shrinking as
well as it having a kind of psychic
impact on the various telepaths who were
there in that area and so as a result of
that the question is what do we do about
this and so the the essential uh
response is like we have to go in and we
have to basically figure out what's
going on now here's a cool thing that
that Jonathan Hickman throws in here and
this is one of the things about Hickman
writing but like Hickman does not do
like a lot of writers do when he when he
basically creates a story and then like
he does everything and like six issues
right it doesn't really work that way
instead it's usually always some kind of
a slow rollout because it's the Slow
Burn right it's one of the reasons why I
always love Hickman writing is because
he takes his time to craft an amazing
story instead of just rushing it all out
super fast and so as a result of that we
learned a couple things here about
krakowa the the island itself insofar
that Hickman really kind of ties into
the original giant size X-Men number one
story and saying that the krakowan
island basically feeds on the psychic
energy of mutants now in previous
stories and in decades gone by the
island wasn't really nefarious so so
much as it had a disregard for mutant
life right it basically it would just
consume the psychic energies of mutants
and didn't really care right it was just
kind of a thing that it did and it was a
role that it played as time has gone on
and especially with the X-Men and the
various mutants using gracoa as a home
it's kind of turned into somewhat of a
of a symbiotic relationship insofar that
krakowa if it really wanted to could
just consume like two mutants every year
in order to keep itself sustained but
what ends up happening is that all the
various mutants across kakoa basically
kind of provide it with the with some
psychic energy that it needs and so the
result is that instead of taking out two
mutants every year basically a ritual
sacrifice is more or less what it would
be it just kind of feeds on the psychic
energy of everybody who's there which is
barely noticeable by anything but here's
the funny thing about this is that
Hickman actually brings back Celine and
we've not seen her yet but Celine is
essentially the oldest mutant in the
world right she's 10 000 years old she
was born during the hiborian age and she
literally feeds on the life forces of
various individuals in order to keep
herself sustained her job here is to
basically alongside implant is to
basically Monitor kakoa and to ensure
that kirkoa's feeding process doesn't
run right and the mutants themselves are
sustaining krakowa the way it needs to
be sustained so it's not a great big
huge thing but it is kind of a cool
little thing to see that like Celine is
still here a character who by all
standards of measurement I thought it
just basically been killed off and
Marvel was never gonna bring her back
but again like what you end up finding
out here is that these forces that have
broken into the Savage land are actually
a bunch of old women
thank you for being a friend so so these
old chicks here they're really just kind
of bickering with each other and
carrying on and so on but they seem
pretty hardcore they seem pretty
ruthless right now we'll find out what
the story is about them here in a second
but here's a funny thing this is why I
love what's going on with with Dawn of X
right we talked about this during fallen
angels that like everything connects
with everything else and so there's kind
of this offhanded comment that's made by
Emma Frost like man I really wish we had
Doug Ramsey that we had Cypher here in
order to basically figure out what's
going on with kokoa talk to it directly
but of course as we know Cipher is off
in space with the New Mutants I think it
is like what team he's on I think it's
the New Mutants and so he's not there
and then of course Cyclops makes a
response by saying yeah that's my fault
because Cyclops is the one that sent
them out right here's one that helped
them gain access to get to Shia space so
it's cool to see these little things
kind of tying into each other but what
they end up doing is basically hitting
up Gateway and so of course he basically
teleports the X-Men or at least this
this kind of Strike Force Team directly
to krakowa and that's when they start
communicating with these these old women
or start talking to them and like they
immediately start talking trash about
Emma Frost they're like yeah man we're a
group called Horticulture but one of
them's just like uh speaking of unsavory
women like that one in the white looks
like a tarp
and it's kind of a funny thing right
like these old chicks just like making
fun of this young chick he's like hey
look sweetheart you could dress however
you want to just know the World's Gonna
kind of view you a certain way right so
if you're okay with that do your thing
but you know just understand you know
like it's kind of a funny little little
scenario like old chicks basically
getting a hard time to young chicks now
here's the funny thing about this is
Emma Frost hits on that right and
basically says okay somehow their minds
are being shielded now because and
that's kind of a good thing right
because as we know Emma Frost is an
Omega Level telepath right she's
insanely powerful so if she wanted to
she could just like shut down the mind
of these old chicks or or basically make
them dress like Tarts according to their
own standards uh it's it's a funny
little thing like in terms of what she
could really do to screw up the minds of
these women but it's sort of a question
there of how is it that these women are
able to Shield their minds from
telepaths how is it they were able to
hack into the uh the curcumin Gateway
Network in order to access the Savage
land and how do they even know about the
Savage land and the first place right
because it's kept very hush hush and so
Sebastian Shaw really begins to speak up
here now here's the thing about
Sebastian Shaw right historically
speaking he's always been a guy who
overplays his hand every single time
without fail but a lot of it's because
of the fact that one he is exceedingly
arrogant and full of hubris and two
because he's still kind of riding off
the heels of having once been the black
king of the hellfire club but the idea
here is that he's used to being in
charge and he's used to getting his way
and so where he usually is charming and
is able to kind of have a way with
various men and women that are out there
by sort of using the silver tongue as
he's going through and talking to these
old women like you fair young beautiful
women and so on you know and we can come
to an agreement right I mean we're cool
people like we can come to an agreement
they immediately spray him in the face
with gas
neutralizes powers and they're like nope
no deal old man and so of course Cyclops
really don't responds in kind but here's
the funny thing is the X-Men don't know
what's going on with this group and
that's one of the things to understand
the role of the X-Men right now is
really more one of politics than
anything else and the reason why I say
that is because sure the X-Men could
annihilate these old women hide their
bodies just be like ricoa take care of
these bodies or just like dump them in
the ocean somewhere or whatever the case
is and and seemingly nobody would
believe that they were gone but they
don't know who sent them it could be
some foreign government and as soon as
the X-Men make the first strike and they
kill these old women well then suddenly
comes out the X-Men are murderers right
so not having all the information not
having all the facts the only thing they
can do is really one keep these women
alive and then two try to figure out
what's going on in terms of how they
access this area and what it does is it
puts all the playing cards in the hands
of these older women because they
control the game now this combined with
the fact that Cyclops is a sack because
like one of the chicks falls down and
she's like oh my God my hip you know you
broke my hip and he's like oh my God I'm
so sorry and she's just like soccer and
then like sprays him in the face I'm
like Cyclops you suck grow some balls
dude that was my immediate response I
was like dude how do you fall for that
man like the chick breaks into your home
basically starts stealing your stuff and
then you're gonna help her out when she
breaks her hip dude I would have just
kicked her in the hip for good measure
and be like yeah man and let that be a
lesson to you don't break into people's
stuff next time I'm kind of cold-blooded
though of course Emma Frost basically
chimes in being well aware of what's
going on we get the story of these
various women here and what they did is
they basically served as this kind of
botanist uh Science Center more or less
you know the group Horticulture itself
focused on using plant life as you know
for various means to improve the world
or or whatever the case happened to be
but the issue is that there were other
scientists who were using their research
as a means to make money and so because
the overarching idea of these three
individual women was to basically reduce
the population of Earth by basically
initiating a kind of Extinction agenda
in order to return the Earth more to a
pristine state right so they're
basically just a bunch of tree huggers
uh the result was that they ended up
killing off all these scientists using
their bodies as a means to grow plants
and then in turn continue their conquest
of returning the Earth to a more
pristine state now the way this would
have worked is it would have been fine
but then suddenly the X-Men pop up from
cocoa basically saying we've got all
these medicines that can extend your
lifespan right and they can cure the
various things that would have otherwise
killed you and so it basically runs
directly counter to the plans of
horticulture themselves and so their
idea was to one analyze what it was that
these plants can do and of course they
can't really get their hands on them in
a reasonable way because of the fact
that one they don't really have the
money to buy them on the black market
they're not part of any real government
figure or I guess control center so you
know they're not part of any governing
body so they can't really buy things on
the front face you know in terms of like
the the public eye so they basically
found a way to hack the Gateway and then
break it into the Savage land and then
steal these various flowers and so on
and so it's kind of funny because you
would expect it to basically lead to
them winning there's really nothing Emma
Frost can do here right because one
there's shielded from telepathic
telepathic abilities it's the only real
ability she has she could go running up
on them in her Diamond form but all they
have to do is spray her with that weird
gas stuff and then her powers are
essentially neutralized there's really
nothing she can do to stop them and so
ultimately they just end up absconding
with her stuff right they just end up
taking uh taking these flowers and
basically leaving and that's essentially
it because then she basically travels
back to uh the secret Island or the
secret Council I'm sorry the quiet
Council of krakowa and says like we
basically have a problem here and this
is something that we're gonna have to
attend to this is cool it doesn't seem
super important right it doesn't seem
like exceedingly important here but it
will be right this will be a major plot
Point going forward it may be that'll be
like 20 issues before it'll become
important but it will be important
somewhere along the launch
okay so we are getting back into the
Marauders and the Marauders is probably
the best comic coming out of Marvel
right now like it's it's amazing um
here's the thing right this is actually
a really really interesting story this
one initially picks up with Sebastian
Shaw right Sebastian Shaw of course
being the black king of the hellfire
club the guy who can absorb pretty much
a limitless amount of energy and turn it
into a physical strength and what he
ends up doing here is he actually ends
up traveling to the five now of course
those of you guys who have been keeping
up with Dawn of X the five are the five
mutants who are responsible for
resurrecting other mutants who have
basically died right each one plays a
particular role in resurrecting various
mutants who are out there now they don't
just do it willy-nilly there's usually a
cause or there has to be a justification
for a mutant being resurrected they have
to serve a particular purpose and this
is really more of like an editorial uh
concept by Marvel to basically ensure
that like writers aren't just
arbitrarily bringing mutants back nobody
wants to see Earnest the Untouchable
comeback I don't know if you guys know
who he was he was a guy who could create
force fields and then suffocated on the
side of his own force field he sucked
like he was a really crappy mutant so
because of that he was a terrible
character because of that oh what we end
up finding out here is that the five at
the request of Sebastian Shaw have
resurrected Shinobi Shaw now I don't
know if you guys know who he is Shinobi
Shaw is basically like the illegitimate
son of Sebastian and he has the ability
to increase or decrease his density
right so he can be like kitty pride and
make himself intangible or he can make
himself super durable like super dense
and almost indestructible right so he's
like vision and that regard the funny
thing about this is that though the way
this plays out or at least the way this
goes down is the questions asked by
Sebastian Shaw will Shinobi remember
anything right anything basically
leading up to the time in which he died
and the response of the five is while he
shouldn't but there's a possibility that
he might it really just depends right so
one of the things that this shows here
is that when a character is resurrected
or characters brought back if their
memories weren't stored inside cerebro
there's no way to guarantee what they
will and won't remember presumably if
their memories were stored inside
cerebro what they could do is engineer
their memory so they come back but don't
remember certain things which is
actually a really cool concept that
could be used if it's done properly in
Marvel Comics but the reason why this
matters is because the first thing
Shinobi asks Shaw is how did I get here
and she all kind of has this
recollection back to when Shinobi died
now here's an important thing about his
character Shinobi was really a result of
Marvel in the early 1990s trying to like
reshuffle the landscape right so we've
talked about this before in X-Men
explained when we explained the
publication history of the of the team
and the idea was that in 1991 Chris
Claremont from 91 to 92 basically bailed
and so in early or really kind of late
1991 John Byrne took over and the reason
why that mattered because John Byrne had
done a lot of the art alongside Chris
Claremont as writer in the X-Men titles
which is really where John Byrne made
his claim to fame that in the artwork he
did on Fantastic Four back in the day
now he also wrote stories where he did
things like She-Hulk so it was like the
first instance where she basically broke
the fourth wall was under John Byrne but
one of the big things that Marvel had
done is they had basically looked at a
lot of the work that Chris Claremont had
done and because he had basically just
left Marvel just was gone like he was
there one day and gone the next and went
over to DC to write that terrible
Sovereign seven story when he had left
Marvel basically wanted to kind of undo
all the stuff that he did or kind of tie
up loose plot threads right so Sebastian
Shaw was kind of considered to be an
archaic holdover Claremont had done a
lot of work with him but the role that
Shaw played was the black king of the
hellfire club and that was a role that
could be occupied by anybody and so the
idea was to basically remove Sebastian
Shaw and replace him with a new
character and so what you ended up
getting was the introduction of Shinobi
and really he kind of got his claim to
fame as part of a group called The
upstarts now the upstarts was a concept
that was introduced because Shinobi I
think first appeared back in the old X
Factor comics and the upstarts were a
group that were introduced back in 1991
when Celine had become the black queen
of the Hellfire Club of course Celine
being a character who she was basically
10 000 years old she'd been around for a
long long time and by him snaking her
way in there what she wanted to do was
basically create her own Inner Circle
and so she had gotten with a guy called
the games master and basically had him
track down and gather together a whole
bunch of different mutants and what they
would do is kill as many other mutants
as they possibly could and then they
would be awarded points the result was
that in in uh Uncanny X-Men issue number
282 you ended up having uh Sebastian
Shaw who was killed or at least
supposedly killed by Shinobi now I
didn't play out Sebastian Shaw actually
ended up Surviving the whole ordeal and
Shinobi because of the fact that by the
time he got to the mid-1990s Marvel was
struggling a lot of the plot threads
that were there from John Byrne ended up
being either picked up or abandoned by
Scott lodell and a few other writers and
so by the time he got into like the late
1990s Shinobi was just a character who
was there he did a few things here and
there but none of them were nearly as
significant as what Sebastian Shaw had
done and so the result of that is that
Shinobi just kind of free-flowed and
kind of graduated and sort of existed
over time until you got to Craig Kyle
with Exeter crochet now Shinobi had been
killed by that point and the result was
that uh during ex-nicrosha because what
you had was Celine returning and
basically having this trans mode virus
which which could essentially Resurrect
The Dead what she did is she brought
back Shinobi and then Shinobi returned
to the landscape yet again of course he
went after Sebastian Shaw a few things
went down then you go on to Matt
rosenberg's uh Uncanny X-Men run Volume
5 in 2018 and early 2019 and then
basically you get to issue number 20 and
Shinobi ends up running his hand through
his through his head and killing himself
and so that's basically why Shinobi
ended up dying more or less Shinobi
explained in like three or four minutes
right I mean I don't know if this
character really warrants a full-on
explanation because he's not really that
significant what I've told you I think
is good enough to really understand his
character but that's why he's here but
the idea behind Sebastian Shaw is to see
whether or not Shinobi really remembers
everything that's basically gone down
and the result is that Shinobi does
right I mean Shinobi tried to actually
take over Sebastian Shaw's role as the
black king at one point in time and I
think he almost succeeded but he
basically been gunning after his father
for quite some time like trying to kill
Sebastian Shaw for quite some time and
resurrecting and coming back and saying
well I still want to kill my dad
indicates that of course he basically
remembers all those various things that
have gone on between the two of them but
the animosity between the two really
seems to have been quelled for the time
being and the reason why is because what
ends up happening here is one Sebastian
Shaw basically has Shinobi put on on a
red suit now this matters if you've been
following Marauders because what we
found out is that originally Sebastian
Shaw was the one who was going to
appoint the Red Queen or the Red King
now his pick of course was going to be
Shinobi but by virtue of some telepathic
finagling and basically some just good
old-fashioned hard work by Emma Frost
she ended up being the one to secure
that position and kitty Pride ended up
becoming the Red Queen of course Kitty
Pride being the pirate Queen right the
pirate Queen of the X-Men and so it's
it's cool I think that's a really cool
name right like the pirate queen of
cocoa that's a badass name I love that
name but basically what is up happening
here is Sebastian Shaw really begins to
just kind of show Shinobi everything
that's going on now the reality of this
is this is really more of kind of a
filler story than anything but it's also
sort of a good way to be introduced to
what's going on if you're getting onto
Marauders late now it's good to see that
this is actually what's happening here
it's good to see the what at least what
Jerry Dugan's doing here is kind of
continually offering new readers away to
kind of get into the story right because
really the first little quarter of this
the first third of this is literally
Sebastian Shaw running out where all the
things that we already know that the
mutant nation of krakowa provides
various medicines to the human world and
the result is that there are some human
Nations that will publicly support the
mutant population and because they do
they basically operate through Emma
Frost as the White Queen of the hellfire
club and she's the one that basically
publicly provides medicines and and
supplies to those various Nations that
publicly support the X-Men for the
various Nations that publicly oppose the
X-Men but secretly desire to get their
hands on their medicines that's where
Sebastian Shaw Comes in he's the black
king therefore he operates inside the
black market and then you have the Red
Queen Kitty Pride who basically travels
from place to place freeing mutants from
Nations that won't allow those mutants
to escape and travel to perkola right so
she's kind of the one that just moves
around from place to place and that's
basically what it is a Sebastian Shaw is
telling his son that goes on here but
it's kind of funny because as you get
into this and as you see the two of them
talking what you see is a lot of
manipulation by Sebastian Shaw what he
basically does here is he really kind of
skews everything and tells his son well
I was the one who was supposed to
appoint the Red King but Emma Frost lied
and she cheated and she was dubious and
she used her powers and really kind of
like demonizing the character of Emma
Frost and making her look bad in the
face of Shinobi by saying like she's
manipulative and she's a terrible person
and she's the one that basically duped
Sebastian Shaw Nikki himself looked like
the good guy and kind of the innocent
person in this now this is important
because what it shows is the lengths by
which Sebastian Shaw will go to to
achieve his goal the Sebastian Shaw has
always and will always be a very
manipulative and villainous character
more or less and that's really kind of
what's going on here and that's the
important thing to bear in mind is
because while you do have a lot of these
various mutants who are serving as part
of krakowa at the end of the day they
all really still do have their own
mechanations now they operate and try to
achieve those mechanations while not
deviating too far away from cocoa so
they can maintain their status right
because what we've seen is that if a
mutant in the case of saber tooth if a
mutant goes runs awry if they become too
extreme they run against krakowa or
possibly even sabotage or jeopardize
krakowa's sovereignty as a nation
they'll be banished right they'll be
locked inside the island of cocoa and
nobody wants to be locked down there
right because it's just a terrible place
to be in you're literally just sitting
there in darkness by yourself presumably
we don't really know what else down
there but Sebastian Shaw in order to
maintain his position and to ensure the
continued use of his power is kind of
manipulative and sort of moving things
around like like chess pieces in his own
favor and his son is no different here
and so ultimately what he basically ends
up saying is you're going to serve as
like the bishop of the Hellfire Club
right now if those guys who are
unfamiliar the hellfire club really are
like chess pieces right the White Queen
The Black Queen the White Queen the
black king the white Rook the black rook
and so on and so forth through all your
various chess pieces until you get to
pawns which are usually deemed as like
henchmen of the hellfire club the idea
of bringing his son on is a bishop is
designed to basically say hey look I
can't really have a red king or a red
queen that positions held for Kitty
Pride but secretly coveting that
position so that if the time comes when
Kitty Pride somehow befalls some Terror
some terrible fate and is somehow killed
or incapable of being able to serve her
purpose well then here's a waiting
member ready to take her place in the
form of should I be shaw how you know
what a coincidence you know that's
really the kind of thing that this
Sebastian Shaw's going for here it's
very manipulative but that's how his
character operates it falls right in
line with the charter of the hellfire
club and so that's when you really find
out how devious he's being here when
Shinobi really asked the question says
how was it that I died here and that's
the thing he doesn't know how he died
that's the one thing Sebastian Shaw
wanted to ensure is that when Shinobi
came back that Shinobi wouldn't know how
it was that he died and that's when
Sebastian Shaw says it was basically the
White Queen and the Red Queen that
conspired against you they conspired
against you to kill you and remove you
from the landscape essentially telling
his son they're the reason why you died
you have to get revenge on them it's
pretty shady
but again this is why I love everything
in dawn of x
okay so we're getting back into
Excalibur and we actually get to see The
Return of them okay here's the thing
technically he's not one of the most
powerful mutants Marvel has but I think
he could be so like we get to see this
guy make his return now what this does
is this initially picks up with Morgan
lefick for those of you guys who who
have read this comic you guys understand
I'm not covering the first three or four
pages because I don't want to spoil who
the person is so don't worry we will
it'll all make sense now remember Morgan
Le Faye has basically taken over Camelot
now that's really kind of what happened
with her character the big issue that we
run into here and the big thing that
we're trying to struggle with here is
why she doesn't just leave Camelot right
because what's really been going on with
their character is that you kind of have
these these Gates of krakowa that are
popping up all over the world not only
that they're actually popping up in
other dimensions too uh where mutants
who have resided there or currently do
reside there in some form or fashion can
access now as far as we're aware Camelot
is the only place we've seen the only
other dimension that exists out there
that we've seen people basically access
these Gates and even then this gets kind
of finicky right because technically
Camelot is inside other worlds another
world exists outside of the Multiverse
so the question becomes how is a crico
is able to reach beyond the Multiverse
and into this other realm in open Gates
right it's an almost insurmountable
amount of power right because then the
question becomes okay reach into like
other universes like create Gates and
other universes that would seem to be
the case the difference here and this is
where things get a little interesting
the difference here is that we would
probably say no uh because you can't
just easily access Another Universe in
the same way that you can when it comes
to being able to access the other world
right being able to access the realm of
Camelot and all that kind of stuff but
the idea here is that when it comes to
like miriana Stern the agent of Morgan
lafaye in basically the main Marvel
universe that their goal early so the
goal that Marianne has been tasked with
is essentially taking out the mutant
threat and like eliminating these Gates
right because really Morgan lafaye just
kind of sees it as an encroachment on
her power now the reality in terms of
why Morgan lafaye hasn't left Camelot
entered into the main Marvel Universe
and solve this problem is because
presumably like as far as we're aware
King Arthur is not there we don't know
where he is we simply know he's not
there and the indication seems to be
that if she left it would open the doors
for somebody to conquer Camelot in her
stead and it's kind of a funny thing
because when she's talking to Marianna
basically what Marianna Stern is saying
is like we know it has something to do
with the guy apocalypse but we're not
100 sure and it's kind of funny because
the response of Morgan lafaye is well if
you think it's emanating from him then
why don't you defeat him right and
that's something that's much much easier
said than done One does not simply walk
up and defeat apocalypse it doesn't just
work that way right the guy's just so op
but again picking up with Betsy Braddock
and these guys one of the funny things
to come about this is that Jubilee's
kids show go basically is able to tap
into the power of fairies um one of the
things we also didn't really do though
people were asking about this and we
probably should have done in the last
video was offer some measure of an
explanation on Shogun shogo is not the
biological child of Jubilee but it's
only she gave birth to shogo or anything
like that and X-Men volume 4 issue
number one there was an attempt there
was really the creation of a character
called arcan who was kind of like the
sister of John Sublime the bacterial
entity Sublime and it was really kind of
building off what it was that that grand
Morrison had done during his run on new
X-Men but essentially RKO is making his
return you know back to Earth and there
was like a meteor shower in this small
village and basically everybody in the
air he was killed but Jubilee found this
baby that was essentially you know his
parents were gone and she ultimately
adopted it and that's basically where
shogo comes from right like just a quick
and dirty explanation and it's basically
been around ever since right now the
reality is it was one of the cool
introductions for Jubilee because it
kept her character interesting as
opposed to her having been like this
vampire at one point but not really kind
of something along those lines is a
little strange her character had
actually kind of been free-floating in
Marvel ever since Generation X came to
an end that was really like where a
character peaked in popularity I think
it was but the overall gist of this is
that when the baby passed through the
dimensional barrier from the main Marvel
Universe into uh Otherworld somehow it
was able to tap into the power of
fairies and we're not really given like
a true explanation on how it's one of
these things where like they're kind of
musing on it and Betsy Braddock's just
kind of like well I mean it's a mortal
baby in this realm so it's exceedingly
powerful the indication seems to be that
because of the baby and because it had
such such an imagination ultimately you
can kind of tap into those magical
abilities that are there whereas as
adults you know as you become educated
your your imagination becomes less of a
significant thing you know with regards
to how your mind works but we're not
really given a hard and fast explanation
but the long and short is that ultimate
at least shogo just kind of takes on the
form that it wants to now the fact
remains here that of course one of the
big things you kind of get and this is
one of the cool things this is why
Gambit's cool depending on how he's
written right and and More in recent
years he wasn't wasn't nearly as
interesting in you as he was like right
after the events of X-Men the Animated
Series right like an X-Men the Animated
Series I think is when he probably
reached his highest level of popularity
but in the years it kind of came after
for about two years after the show went
off the air he was still pretty cool and
then he just kind of became a background
character but his love of Rogue is what
makes him interesting right because with
his powers just being the ability to
basically kinetically charge objects
it's okay I mean it's like okay cool you
know whatever it's a fraction of what it
used to be right you read the new Sun
story and it's just like dude this guy
could have just like blown up planets
but focusing on The Human Side of him
that's what makes him interesting and
one of the things that he does is he
basically lashes out a jubilee and at a
Betsy Braddock right because he's like
none of you all here you can pitch me
whatever story you want to but Rogue is
literally sitting in a box on the other
side of this Dimension you know and
she's just kind of there by herself and
we have no idea what's going on with her
not only that she's being watched over
by apocalypse the last Security in the
world I would ever trust and remember
gamut's not just saying this to say it
he's saying it because he was a Horseman
of Apocalypse once he has an intimate
understanding both through that
experience as well as having fought
apocalypse multiple times over the years
that apocalypse is not necessarily the
most trustworthy character out there and
so putting the life of Rogue in the
hands of a character who's dubious at
best you know and who is incredibly
overpowered and could potentially even
take Rogue and turn her into a Horseman
because it suits what it is that he
wants to do is the last thing Gambit
wants to do and as his stance here is
like you guys never would have left
somebody over there like that right like
you Jubilee actually went to the other
dimension and got your child and brought
him back because you didn't want him to
be there with apocalypse you Betsy
Braddock never would have left and
somebody that you cared about in the
hands of Apocalypse but you're telling
me with a straight face that I need to
do it because it's the right thing to do
get out of here and it's so cool because
it's like you guys are so full of crap
you guys are pitching me this because
you want to complete a mission you don't
care about Rogue you care about your
mission like what you care about is
getting Ryan Braddock back and you'll
say whatever you need to in order to
make it happen it's amazing like it's
this amazing back and forth because what
it does is it shows how much Gambit
cares about Rogue and his mind there's
Rogue and then everything else and
that's true based on the the interaction
the two have had over the years and even
the story that we got when they were
married for a short amount of time like
Gambit you know like any man who's in
love with the woman that he's with would
let the world burn before he let
anything happen to her and it's a cool
thing to see that in the character of
Gambit because it makes him more
tangible and more relatable and I think
it's probably some of the best handling
of his character in quite some time
actually so I love seeing his character
depict him in this faction the issue
with this is of course once they
basically end up traveling to the castle
of Morgan lafaye in an effort to
basically try to break in and get Brian
Braddock when they get there then like
they're met by all these magically
enhanced Knights and the results of this
is that where you also end up getting is
the inability for Betsy Braddock to
dominate their minds all she can do is
read their surface thoughts now this is
a byproduct of of Morgan lafay basically
using her Magics to kind of protect her
various nights that are there and that's
one of the important things to
understand is that while Morgan lafaye
doesn't really play a hand in dealing
with like the X-Men right you don't
really see her fight the X-Men she's not
oblivious to them right it's not like
she's on aware of what the X-Men can do
or what they're capable of and even
people with just telepathy right because
the extra aren't the only ones who have
it being able to understand that power
and understand what someone like Betsy
spider can do and then fortify her
forces against that really show just how
capable Morgan Le Faye is and so what
you end up getting here is Brian
Braddock who again was previously
transformed into the Black Knight who
arrives on the scene now remember the
longer he stays under the spell of
Morgan lafay the longer he stays under
her control the further and further he
gets away from himself and so what you
get are these small little moments here
and there right like he basically goes
to attack Betsy Braddock the two of them
fight and you get these small little
moments right where she's mentioning
names like Megan the wife of Ryan
Braddock where she's saying things like
your brother Jamie has come back and so
on and so forth and some of these things
kind of resonate with him to a degree
but before anything can happen suddenly
of course you basically have shogo who
shows up uses dragon flame to kind of
spray everything down and Brian seems to
kind of have this recollection of who he
is but then he's whisked away by Morgan
Le Faye and so what it does is it kind
of gives us this little bit of a glimpse
you know with the possibility that Brian
can make his return maybe he'll go back
to being Captain Britain maybe it'll be
Betsy Braddock right I mean you know
Brian has been Captain Britain for
decades so maybe it's time for somebody
else to take over the mantle but he is
also a Mainstay in in like the British
side of Marvel Comics right I mean it's
like it's like if Steve Rogers was no
longer Captain America anymore right I
mean you could lose the mantle but then
ultimately if you've been reading Marvel
Comics long enough you know that he
would come back right so that's exactly
how it is with Brian Braddock and so
that's why it's kind of cool to see this
because for me it's not it's not really
an issue of oh my God Brian Braddock's
never going to be Captain Britney again
right be foolishing me to believe that
but what what is interesting to me is
how's it going to come back and go back
to being Captain Britain again that's
what I want to see that's what intrigues
me and so as a result of this what you
end up having is really apocalypse kind
of getting frustrated with his ability
to understand how these Magics work with
regards to like Otherworld and the Druid
Magics and the Magics of Planet Kappa
are those individuals who were once you
know led by apocalypse who he ultimately
abandoned his inability to really tap
into magic now this is important because
what this shows is really kind of an
unofficial weakness of Apocalypse not a
physical weakness none of so far as like
if faced by somebody who can use magic
he will ultimately be defeated uh what
it means is it like there are elements
and things out there that apocalypse
still doesn't really understand and
that's kind of important because of
course she's been around for 5 000 years
but it's one of these things where
Marvel's basically saying yes he's old
but he has not seen and done at all he's
seen and done a lot and so it's kind of
a cool little thing because what he says
is like okay I can't really tap into
these things I can't really like control
these these Stones the way that I need
to I need to find someone who can and so
what he ends up doing here is actually
leaving Cornwall and then traveling to
like Central Park it looks like and
people just kind of like dude is that
such and such and it's just kind of like
dude don't stare man like don't stare
and it's kind of crazy he just like
boldly walks through the park
and makes his way finally to like this
apartment complex and when he walks in
there he rips the door all this
apartment you know this kid is like what
the heck is going on and apocalypse just
like be quiet kid like you need to come
with me now the question is who is this
kid this kid is Julio Richter also known
as simply just Richter and he is one of
the most powerful mutants in Marvel
Comics I think now he's not powerful
insofar as he has like extreme reality
manipulation powers or anything like
that he does have clairvoyance that is
to say the ability to like see into the
future understand people's emotions
different things like that but I think
probably the the really the main focal
point of his power is the ability to
control the Earth he was one of those
characters that originally lost his
powers during the events of House of M
and then during Children's Crusade
goddess powers back but like that's the
thing like sometime really recently like
you know during the events of house and
powers of X he seemed to have lost
control of them and so he was always
kind of afraid of going to kakoa because
he was afraid he would shake the island
apart the reality and this is one of the
important things apocalypse is just like
one you can't be afraid you have to
learn to harness your power right your
power is part of you you have to learn
to harness and control it but two
apocalypse makes a very important thing
he's like you can basically alter and
and like change the world miles below
the surface right now what this does and
this is one of the funny things about it
by my definition of Omega Level it makes
him an Omega Level threat or at least an
Omega Level mutant and the reason why is
because his power is literally like
Earth base meaning he's a danger to the
Earth itself now technically speaking
Omega Level is like there's no
definitive upper limit to that power and
because of the fact that he manipulates
planets I would say that like if given
enough time line if he's able to like
control it enough he can move like other
planets and things like that which would
be absolutely Beast to be able to see
but Richter's like one of these unsung
heroes of Marvel like one of these
unsung heroes of the X-Men but that's
the thing like like literally this guy
could just like crack the Earth in two
if he wanted to and that's what he's
afraid of right like being unable to
control his powers that like they would
eventually go awry he would basically
cracked the Earth in half he would
destroy the entire world is what he's
afraid of and he actually could like he
legitimately could if he lost control
over his powers were pushed to the
extreme all you would need is the same
kind of scenario to unfold after Emma
Frost woke up from her coma when she was
attacked released when all the hellions
died and then she took over the body of
Iceman and then realized that like Bobby
Drake is an Omega Level mutant if his
powers are pushed high enough that's the
exact same thing you need with Richter
but that's why he's basically been
brought in by apocalypse is like I need
you to be able to one like use your
Clairvoyance powers and then two to also
use your powers to control the Earth to
help me basically understand everything
going on with these stones and so on and
so forth but what we also end up finding
out here is that mi-13 is on the hunt
for the new captain or for Captain
Britain because it's a necessary
character for England itself and the a
person who shows up here is none other
than Pete wisdom now Pete wisdom is cool
he's not really cool in terms of powers
he's got these like you know solar
knives basically like these these
flaming knives he absorbs like ambient
solar energy and then creates like
knives out of him and stuff like that
but what it basically means is like
Marvel's pulling out all the stops we're
like a lot of the British characters
things are about to pop off is basically
what this means
the Excalibur stores are gearing up for
some pretty big things
okay so we are continuing on and picking
up with uh New Mutants issue number
three now here's a cool thing New
Mutants issue number three actually kind
of deviates away from what we've seen so
far um instead it actually travels back
to Earth and focuses on a character
named armor now this is kind of
interesting right to really like bring
armor seemingly out of nowhere along
with uh Tabitha Smith with boom boom and
then glob but here's the thing all right
so this initially picks up really with
with armor and and glob just kind of
enjoying krakowa right now this is a
cool little moment here it's a cool
little exchange because it's something
that we don't really see I mean we kind
of saw it in the beginning to a degree
but we only saw it in so far as it was
focusing on like the peaceful nature
right really the idea that mutants had a
home but it wasn't really focusing on
like the whole party aspect of it all
and that's one of the things that given
everything in dawn of X is easy for
writers to miss and it's it's good to
see that they're not this is the reason
why like New Mutants is probably the
best Story coming out of Marvel at the
moment is because what you have here is
you have this scenario where armor is
just sort of looking at what's going on
at the moment and everybody's just kind
of partying and having a good time cook
HOA looks like a blast right it looks
like the most fun ever but and the other
half of this is that for the character
of of armor one of the things she kind
of Longs for is some of the members that
that were either part of New Mutants or
dealt with like the younger members that
really like the New Mutants themselves
that weren't officially part of the team
who really aren't there just people
she's known over the years and people
she's been friends with who aren't
really there on krakowa itself and
specifically this really comes down to
the character of beak now this really
sort of plays itself out where she goes
to visit stage right now Sage is a
character we've kind of talked about you
know occasionally over the course of
Marvel we've never really gone super
super in depth into and we don't really
need to the nature of sage is that her
brain works like a computer right so she
never forgets information and it
categorizes and organizes that
information perfectly right so imagine
like Bradley Cooper from Limitless and
that's basically Sage uh it's one of
these things where like like armor kind
of sits down and says well let's kind of
go through like who's who's registered
and who's not registered who's here and
who's not here right now we don't get
like a full list right Ed Brisson
doesn't give us like a full breakdown of
everyone right because the mutant
population while it's not as high as it
was before the events of House of M is
certainly a lot higher than it was after
the events of the House of Emirates so
there's still thousands of mutants out
there as opposed to like the millions
that were there before and so what this
what this would do is it would end up
being like probably like a giant sized
comic right so like a double-sized comic
where it's like you know I don't know 44
Pages or like 46 pages and it would just
be nothing but names
it'd be the least interesting comic book
ever with the fact remains that she's
kind of going through this list of
people so like Bishop of course is
registered so on and so forth but
characters like beak are not there and
so what she ends up doing is kind of
saying okay well like let's go see if we
can find them right let's go see if we
could find these guys and so what she
ends up doing is of course going and
speaking directly with glob and glob
it's kind of a funny thing right because
one of the things he hits on is like
Well everybody's in more of a peaceful
state right so people people aren't
really on edge and that's one of the
cool things to kind of take note of and
it's one of the things to overlook
that's easy to overlook when it comes to
dawn of X right like you look at the
nature of krakowa and despite the death
of Xavier which really sort of caught
everybody off guard different things
like that for the most part people
aren't nearly as on edge as they were
before right that's one of the big kind
of tonal changes that you notice just
going on with the X-Men right now right
if you were to go and read X-Men pretty
much any time before Jonathan Hickman
took it over the overall tone of the
X-Men is today might be my last day on
Earth and while it's not the worst thing
ever after a while it does kind of get
old and so it's good to see it kind of
take a reprieve now the reality is it
took like 50 years for it to get old
right so I guess that says something
about the nature of X-Men storytelling
but it is cool to kind of see it and see
see the various mutants on Earth in a
position to where they're not always
like on edge and feeling like everything
is going to come to an end to see them
just kind of enjoying their lives right
and so glad asks the question like do
you think pixie would be into me and and
it's kind of interesting there because
my thought reading this was like dude
shoot your shot man like the worst you
can do is say no and you miss 100 of the
shots you don't take man so like walk up
to the girl and say hey like do you want
to get dinner on Friday and then like
she's gonna say yes or she's gonna say
no if she says no it's not the end of
the world if she says yes we're off to
the races home slice you better dress
your best man you better learn those
manners
so it's it's cool to see these small
little things and this is the reason why
I say New Mutants is so cool I mean we
hit on this time and time again when it
comes to like focusing on the new Mutant
team right it's it's designed to be
light-hearted it's designed to be a
story where it focuses on like the
struggles of teenagers and different
things like that you know these younger
kids getting out into the world and
getting out there exploring like the
dating life and falling in love and out
of love and different things like that
it's these cool little moments and it's
things that kind of allow us to sort of
tap back into when we were teenagers and
to kind of look back and be like why was
I so worried about that
why why did I think that was so
important at the time but what ends up
happening here is armor travels to where
Robert DeCosta is and meets with boom
boom now at this point she doesn't
really know her I guess she's kind of
figuring it out that they've basically
taken off to space you know to go hang
out with Sam Guthrie and all them so
that's what we've really covered with
New Mutants issue one and two but uh
it's interesting to see boom boom here
right you know boom boom is an old
school character Tabitha Smith she goes
back to 1985 right so she's not new she
appeared back in secret Wars 2 I think
it was uh but she's a character that can
create these sort of like plasma bombs
and what they do is they explode with a
concussive force uh and the impact of
the bombs is relative to their size
right so if it's the size of a golf ball
it'll be enough to like you know hurt
you or something like that to maybe
knock you down but if it's the size of
like a beach ball it'll punch a hole
through metal right now uh over the
years the ability for her to demonstrate
control over her powers is kind of waxed
and waned and a lot of that's because
the biggest emphasis that came with boom
boom was really like with her and
Richter her Richter and a few other
people is part of like X-Force and like
her time with X Factor back during uh I
think it was Walter and Louise Simon run
and then during Rob liefeld's run on
X-Force I'm not going to swear to that
after that she's just kind of been
around right and not a whole lot has
been done with her character but she's
just an old school character right she's
a Legacy character so she's always just
kind of been around but it's interesting
to sort of see her be involved here
because what she wants is Adventure
she's bored out of her mind she's like
there's nothing to do here she's
Restless right like she longed for that
adventurous life but ultimately she ends
up settling with armor uh what she
basically says well let's go out and
let's go see if we can't find vegan and
these various characters and so what
this does is of course it leads to them
grabbing a couple people along the way
and then traveling out to Nebraska now
the reality was that when when armor
told Tabitha they were going to be going
to Nebraska it's like well that kind of
sucks and understandably so because
Nebraska only has two things going for
it nothing and the Corn Huskers it's
always like okay you know I guess but
when they do of course they arrive at
the home of beak himself now here's the
interesting thing when it comes to beak
we had a little bit of explanation here
Beacon made his debut back in new X-Men
issue number 117 that was really the
tail end of uh the ES4 Extinction of I'm
like Cassandra Nova wiped out 16 million
mutants in the island of genocia but for
beak himself uh with his introduction
going into some of his later appearances
in new X-Men it was really focusing on
the love interest between himself and
Angel Salvatore now eventually Beak was
basically taken off off the new X-Men
and thrown directly into the Exile
storylines in my opinion I really kind
of felt like the Exiles team was kind of
the unsellables the characters just that
were just characters really couldn't
hold a story or really couldn't hold
their own comic it was just kind of a
place to throw characters the Post House
of M Exile stories were amazing right
like like Exiles World Tour that was
amazing right when they went to like the
2099 universe and like the future in
perfect Universe it was cool that they
jumped around from reality to reality
but the issue with it was really just
trying to find a place for beak in like
the Marvel landscape at the time and
this lasted for a number of years now
eventually he returned back and uh
actually lost his powers for a Time
reverted to like a human form and then
basically took up residence with Angel
Salvatore the funny thing was that when
they were both at the Xavier school he
got her Knocked Up
she ended up getting pregnant but
basically this is just kind of the
situation where they've essentially
retreated away from krakowa and
basically taken up residence in Nebraska
and the question was why right like why
why did they ended up basically
rejecting the idea of moving to curcoa
and the reason why is because the the
father really seemingly the father of of
beak himself is dealing with Taylor
Ellis disease now I thought this was an
actual disease and I looked it up
apparently it's not but it's basically
in at least in in this story as it's
told it's a really really rare version
of dementia that basically begins to
just kind of break down the body to the
point where people die exceedingly fast
right like it was named after a guy
named Taylor Ellis who died four months
after originally Contracting the disease
that he ended up uh ended up dying from
it but that's basically what the father
of beak is suffering from and that's why
they chose not to go now this is cool
right this this is I mean it's not cool
that his father's dying but it's a cool
concept insofar as one of the things
that that tends to get lost when it
comes to comic books is that you sort of
see this tendency where like the
characters move from like one major
event to the next there really is no
down time in between you don't really
get a lot of of tidbits in there in
terms of like what they're doing with
their own personal life the X-Men kind
of doing meaningful things or showing us
what's going on in the back end while
they're why they're doing some of the
things that they're doing on a more
personal level and so it's cool to see
that that beak's character is kind of
being expanded if only so far is to show
his life outside of the X-Men and why he
chose not to go to kakawa that his
father was basically dying and the
result was that he didn't do that
because he wanted to spend as much time
with his father as he could now the cool
thing about this is that armor shows up
it says what but on kakawa we have
medicines that can cure this kind of
stuff she injects it into the father of
of beak and he makes a recovery like
that and it's awesome because what this
does is it gives beak the kind of
satisfaction he was looking for and so
far his father basically returning and
then gives them a reason to return to
the X-Men it's a cool moment right it's
a it's a cool meaningful and beautiful
little moment right because like who of
us have lost a family member to
something like this and what would we
have not given to have somebody come
along with seemingly some kind of
miracle cure it takes an injection and
the world is fixed right like everything
is okay again it's a great little
relatable moment and I absolutely adore
it like I think it's beautifully done
the issue with this is that once this
once this cure is applied to the father
of geek then of course once they go
upstairs big ass armored like did you
bring anybody else and she's like no and
there's just a bunch of crazy folks
outside and they basically smash the
kids up and and like things are popping
off and it's kind of nuts here because
what this guy does is he shows up and he
says look like you guys have all these
medicines right like you mutants have
all these medicines and you've denied
them to our people so like you're gonna
give them to us now or like we're gonna
take everybody out now it's not a great
big huge thing but it's not a great big
huge earth-shattering thing it's a small
little thing but I love little moments
like this I love little stories like
this right because at most this will be
a two possibly three issue Arc and
that'll be it right this will probably
conclude in issue number four if that
right it'll just it'll start and end
really really quickly but I love these
small little things right because what
it shows is you get these small little
conflicts that go on they're not huge
they're not like a great big crossover
right like you're not going to see The
Avengers show up here and like help
armor against these guys there's no
reason for you too I just like these
small little things here right but it
also shows kind of how the world is
dealing with the idea that mutants are
having a far more impactful impactful
approach there because these guys show
up with like power dampening missiles
it's these cool little things right
because armor kind of jumps in she of
course has the ability to kind of create
this sort of psionic armor on herself
that's actually pretty powerful like
it's pretty durable in terms of how she
impacts and how she deals with various
other people out there but it's like a
small little Skirmish and what we're
likely going to see here is kind of a
display of what it is a beast capable of
and the reason why that matters is
because historically speaking Beak was a
character who has never really taken
seriously and so that's why it's gonna
be a small little thing right because
beak will basically be able to kind of
come out here fight alongside the other
mutants who are there and it's going to
be Ed Bruce's way of saying hey like
here's why beak matters here's what his
powers are here's what he's capable of
and like this is why he'd be an
interesting addition to the X-Men and
most likely it'll be the reason why he
ends up returning
okay so we're continuing on with X-Force
and in this video we're actually going
to cover X-Force and Fallen Angels at
the same time I just kind of make up a
little bit because they're really
supposed to follow one after the other
so in terms of reading order for those
of you guys who are unsure uh you'll
find a playlist to the X-Men down in the
description of this video and uh that'll
have the chronological order basically
for all the comics and everything that
are coming out but in the last video
when it came to X-Force we of course had
basically dealt with the aftermath of
the death of Xavier and this idea that
there was some Force out there some
group out there that was attempting to
basically thwart or to eliminate the the
mutants of krakowa right and the idea
was to kill off their leadership and
it'll leave the rest of them kind of
scattered and and leaderless you know
essentially and not really knowing what
to do right and that would basically
leave the field open for an easy attack
if there's no one to give the orders no
one knows who they're taking their
orders from which means that it's just
kind of pandemonium and panic and it's
much easier to defeat a scattered Force
than it is a unified Force you know with
that being the case the question then
became who was the group that did this
and that's where Wolverine came into
play right Wolverine kind of went off on
his own mission to find out what was
going on to basically figure out how it
was they managed to to make themselves
you know seem like Domino to the
computers of curcoa and then access the
island itself and so what we ended up
finding out was that one Quentin choir
had been conducting this mission on his
own albeit Without Really joining kirkoa
and then two they were basically just
removing parts of domino skin and then
grafting it to cyborgs basically Living
Weapons that were being created and then
in turn sending those into to take out
mutants and krakowa and so the question
still kind of remains who's this enemy
Force who's doing this but at the same
time as quentinquier gonna join them and
the reason why is because of course when
you pick up with Domino and you pick up
with Wolverine basically talking to her
a little bit or at least trying to grasp
what's going on the entire group's met
by one of these giant you know gigantic
synthesized humans or synthesized beings
or what have you but it's kind of a cool
thing because when that goes down one of
the things you have to you have to
recognize that they can't really use
their powers right because from the
response of Clinton choir and really
from the response of Wolverine there's a
mutant dampener that exists around there
somewhere that's shutting down their
ability to use their powers and so as a
result of that of course then Domino
basically chimes in and says the things
around my neck you know power inhibitor
and then once it's removed by Wolverine
dominoes abilities come back as well as
Clinton choir and Wolverine now Domino's
abilities are essential here and it's
the only real means by which they're
going to be able to make their escape
and the reason why is because Domino's
is a mutant with the ability to
essentially Bend luck in her favor right
so things just kind of happen to work
out for her now we've seen that manifest
in a variety of different ways over the
years of Marvel Comics it hasn't really
been anything big you know like she
needed to find some ship to get her out
of some place and so she happened to
cross one and then happened to knew how
to Pilot it but it's not really like her
powers used as a plot device in some
ways it is and that was especially
prevalent back in the 1990s but in this
day and age it's really she's so
underused that her powers aren't really
aren't really used as a plot device
because you see her in like one out of
every 100 Comics that Marvel will create
or something like that and honestly what
you're seeing with her here is about the
biggest role she's played since you had
Greg Pax run on X-Force uh during Marvel
Now 2.0 or whatever it was but the fact
remains that having her on their side of
course having her color removed which in
turn proved to be the inhibitor that was
preventing Wolverine's healing factor
and quit inquires Omega Level psychic
powers from working basically proves to
be the thing that allows them to come
have overcome this giant monster and
then just sort of go from there but it's
kind of nuts because what it does is it
switches over to to Jean Gray and Beast
right and the questions really asked
here by both by really by beasts more so
than Jean Gray but the question is asked
what's the future of this going to look
like right I mean Humanity can't know
that a successful mission to kill
Charles Xavier had happened despite the
fact that they can bring him back
Humanity can't know the mutants have an
ability to resurrect themselves right
because then Humanity will hit the panic
button you know they'll start to freak
out what if they resurrect some crazy
meat and wants to kill everybody or
something like that you know Humanity
was hard to freak out over that regard
because mutants can't die or Humanity
would covet that ability and they would
try to find a way to take it but the
other reason is because if Humanity
learned that Charles Xavier was
successfully assassinated then what it
would mean is that krakowa can be can be
infiltrated can be taken out and those
groups who were friends groups who would
have otherwise never really done it
because they weren't really sure if it
would work or not would now see it as a
legitimate thing like okay well I mean
if Xavier could died once again die once
then all the mutants can die right so
like we can all infiltrate and then
suddenly what you end up with is this
Mad Dash this kind of great Gold Rush by
various anti-mutant groups out there all
trying to kill the mutant population on
Cocoa right that's the last thing they
need is for the island to turn into just
a giant house of death and so of course
as we expected and as we were told
previously Charles Xavier is
successfully resurrected uh and then in
turn you switch over to Magneto
alongside black Tom Cassidy now of
course you have all these various forces
all these various you know news groups
and things like that who are out there
who are reporting and who are just like
is Charles Xavier really dead you know
asking all these questions and where
Magneto initially goes to answer and
tries to do it in a way that tries to
essentially Dodge the question by not
saying yes he's dead but we're going to
resurrect him instead the resurrected
Charles Xavier pops up and basically
says no everything's fine right like I'm
just as alive as I ever was now this
basically quells what passes for
hysteria not really hysteria but you
know this desire for the world to know
if Charles Xavier was really killed and
one of the questions asked like are you
really Xavier how do we know you're not
a shape-shifter or something like that
the response is well you're just gonna
have to believe me right you're gonna
have to trust that I'm telling you the
truth which is kind of a big stretch you
know to ask you Andy to trust mutant
Khan but hidden kindness for the most
part try to stay on their own and that's
where things really begin to turn
because we're you know you look at House
of X you look at powers of X you look at
the X-Men look at everything going on up
until now the desire of Xavier was let's
see if we can make this work what this
is showing is that relations between
humans and mutants simply just can't
work there will always be some Fringe
group out there who will try to take out
the mutant population and if it's one
Fringe group if it's one Fringe group
that will do it then you might as well
assume the rest of humanity wants to do
it right and so while it's not
necessarily mutants going to war with
humans it's mutants certainly saying
like we have to figure out what's going
on here right I mean the initial
response when the questions asked you
know of Magneto like what did you guys
say when you were talking to the press
this responses well of course we denied
it we told him that Xavier never died
like he wasn't he wasn't killed we don't
know where you got this from but he's
very much alive instead Xavier's
response is we must respond in kind
right they tried to take me out like
they tried to kill me you know they were
operating from the Shadows or whatever
it is we're gonna respond in con so what
he basically says is like I've studied
my enemy you know I've studied them I've
determined what they're trying to do
with us they're basically bioengineering
themselves to try to make themselves
comparable to us they're trying to
create mutants of their own more or less
using technological engineering or
whatever the case is but that's fine if
that's what they want to do then we'll
find find them and will strike them from
the Shadows just like they struck at us
it's Xavier taking an offensive hand
basically saying they struck first now
we strike back and it's it's a smart
move but it's also a very dangerous move
because if it's learned that's what the
mutant population is doing then as we
know Humanity won't care right I mean in
this day and age it doesn't matter
whether or not you're right and wrong it
matters whether or not somebody agrees
with what you're doing and that's
basically what it would come down to
right Humanity wouldn't really care
whether they were right or wrong social
media in this day and age they're just
looking for a reason to be upset and so
that's exactly what would go on here
like Humanity would just kind of look at
that and say you struck one of us and
where you would look at and you would
say yeah but you guys struck first
Humanity would say we don't care right
like you struck at us so now we're gonna
take you out and so it could you know
could potentially lead to an all-out war
between these two groups which is
exceedingly dangerous in and of itself
not only that of course we end up
learning this organization that managed
to take out Charles Xavier is still
alive and well they're referring to
themselves as Xena but we don't know who
they are right they're hidden they're
they're covered we don't really know who
they are we don't know where they come
from we don't know exactly what's going
on I would risk because one of these
guys here is enormous I would risk I go
on a limb and I would say that's
probably Kane Marco that might be
Juggernaut I don't know if it's true or
not but he looks big enough to be that
guy but I guess we'll find out here in
the next couple issues or so but no
matter how you slice it and how you look
at it the reality of this is this is how
Wars begin this is how Wars start right
it starts with a pot shot which turns
into a response which turns into
escalating conflict which goes into
full-scale war between two groups two
organizations whatever the case is and
so this is how it all begins this is how
it all starts is with the X-Men
responding to an initial attack that was
launched by humanity and so what I want
to do here is I want to jump over to
Fallen Angels now fallen angels if you
guys recall we were largely focusing on
on quanen on basically the Japanese
version of psylocke more or less that's
how you want to look at her alongside
cable and x23 and the idea was that they
were trying to track down this substance
that was called overclock right this
kind of you know cybernetic drug that
could basically be given to people and
then in turn transform them what seemed
to you know seem to be into cyborgs with
augmented abilities and whatnot the the
side plot that was kind of going on with
this was that uh Quantum was basically
teaching x23 how to hardest and use her
anger for her own ends and that was one
of the things that she never really
learned from Wolverine right I mean
Wolverine doesn't even really do that
Wolverine uses his anger to a degree but
if it gets too extreme then he goes into
a Berserker rage right and so that's one
of the things you kind of have to keep
in mind that this sort of kicks off here
is that when they were traveling to
Brazil in order to locate this place
that was creating overclock where they
were basically using children either to
experiment on or or as subjects or what
have you that they were immediately
ambushed and that's one of the things
that goes on here is that in turn you
immediately have you initially have x-23
who kind of seems to lash out to a
degree but then is immediately pulled in
by Quantum and the reason why is because
Quantum basically tells her like there's
a lot of rage in you and I can
appreciate that right but you're trying
to hold back this is not a time to hold
back this is a time to let loose we're
facing an enemy here that deserves your
rage we're facing an enemy here that
deserves to die in the worst ways so let
your rage run loose let it run rampant
let it get out there and let it do its
thing but keep it under control and
that's kind of a difficult scenario to
do right it's kind of a difficult thing
to achieve to allow yourself to kind of
almost enter this feral Berserker state
but keep it under control at the same
time but the reality of this is 23 is
their best chance of overcoming this
colossal monstrous colossal machine more
or less has been sent after them because
of course she has a healing Factor so
she can heal from pretty much anything
but she's also got adamantium claws and
so keeping her rage under under control
but using it as a source to kind of
allow her to lash out and almost become
something akin to a Mindless machine she
achieves her goal right she basically
takes out and destroys this machine but
as she goes through with it she
basically ends up discovering this young
kid and then initially where she was
going to attack in kind of her mindless
rage she's pulled back by Quantum and
this is kind of the lesson that's being
learned here and in a lot of ways and if
you're if you're if you're looking at
this in a lot of ways you can almost
kind of see x23 being turned into a
weapon to be used by Quantum to achieve
her goals scanning this mind of this
young kid Quantum basically seems to
learn everything that's going on but the
other half of this is that cable of
course was captured and so when cable
was taken this basically allows you know
allows this kind of entity more or less
to appear to him although we don't
really get a full a full brunt on what
it is instead it basically starts saying
like let me let me tell you about your
future let me show you what it is that
you can become cable is temporarily
incapacitated and then in turn you know
what it basically says is like what
we're trying to achieve here you know
with this this entity that's talking to
him it's like what we're trying to
achieve here is a state of peacefulness
we're trying to achieve a state where
there is no individuality there's no war
no none of that stuff right it's all
basically one mind we're trying to
create one cohesive mind and it's kind
of an interesting thing to do an
interesting thing to say right because
creating a scenario where there is no
individuality sure it would eliminate
War right like we saw that during
Annihilation Conquest when Ultron was
trying to conquer the universe we
basically had those who were kind of
brought into the Phalanx and then they
became part of the hive mind right so
all sense of individuality except for
those who were particular individuals
like Gamora or somebody like that who
would serve a certain purpose they lost
all sense of individuality They carried
out the mantle of the hive mind and true
it did lead to a lack of War right it
led to a removal of War conflict all
that kind of stuff everything was done
for the purpose of ensuring the survival
of the hive mind and in that creating a
quote-unquote better Society now I guess
a better Society is relative to who it
is of espousing the idea of a better
Society but that's kind of what seems to
be going on here not only that there's
this kind of debate that goes on between
Quantum and x23 the reason why is
because initially like with cable being
being kidnapped and taken to one
location and then Quan and learning the
location of these kids that are
basically being used by apoth as test
subjects then the question becomes which
one do we go to right which one do we
deal with and the initial response of of
x23 is we have to go get cable you know
he basically bought us time so we could
achieve this made it possible for us to
track all the sound in the first place
the response of quantiness cable can
take care of himself we need to go save
these kits right and it's kind of a
tugging right each one has her own
individual tug with x23 it's loyalty
right loyalty to Cable he's one of us
he's part of our team we look out for
our own we have to go save him because
he's one of our own for Quan and I would
say she's probably in the wrong here
because her whole thing is well we have
to find a way to basically save these
kids and we have to stop apoth but apoth
is one of a Litany of organisms and
individuals who are out there that are
trying to destroy mutant kind right so
what makes that more important than
anything else if it's equally important
to everything else then you focus on
cable and then go back and deal with him
later I mean sure it's gonna suck that
some kids were experimented on but at
the end of the day you got to look out
for your own right other otherwise why
even have a team in the first place
that's how you end up destroying loyalty
and so ultimately x23 ends up basically
going with with Quantum and they end up
end up you know tracking down these kits
at the same time you have this weird
crazy looking machine thing that
basically appears to cable and says you
are what it is that we're trying to
achieve you're the Perfect Blend between
human and machine components we want to
create more of you essentially it seems
like what they're trying to do is create
more cables albeit without individuality
but cable himself is a bit of a is a bit
of an outlier right and the reason why
is because cable is the way he is
because he was infected with a
techno-organic virus as a baby which
basically Works to turn organic material
into machinery and it was done by
apocalypse as a means to test whether or
not cable was worthy of being a new host
now of course led to Cable going into
the future and that whole crazy origin
that Marvel tried to take care of over
the course of the last 30 years and it
never worked but the fact remains that
the cable is is kind of like this
perfect blending but it's not really
something that happens seamlessly right
cable has to constantly use his
telepathy and telekinesis to keep the
virus from eating his body alive and
there's been a couple instances where he
uses his powers you know really kind of
diverts his Focus away from keeping the
virus from killing him and focuses on
something else and that virus starts to
overtake his body like that right it
like there was one point where I think
in a matter of minutes it almost killed
him that's how he functions right if
something that happens 24 hours a day
seven days a week and given his his
ability given how fine-tuned his
understanding and his ability to control
his celebrity and telekinesis is at this
point it's just subconscious but this
entity basically says I am not apoth I
speak on behalf of apoth we're trying to
create Perfection basically it's almost
kind of like a like the Borg from a Star
Trek is really what it seems like the
real question I have here is if this is
the case and they're trying to blend
Machinery with human components and
create a singular kind of perfection
then it would seem to me that apoth is
probably a computer system it's probably
what it is like it's a computer or some
kind of Android or something along those
lines but again we don't really know yet
okay so we are getting back into the
X-Men we are with Jonathan Hickman's
X-Men part four now here's an important
thing all right I want to point this out
right off the bat one of the questions
that a lot of you guys ask is when do
comic books take place right like when
does Marvel Comics when do these events
happen and Marvel for the most part does
not really provide definitive dates they
really haven't for a long time really
since 1980 Something I think was the
last time they provided definitive date
Chris Claremont was the last one to do
it occasionally they will right they
don't do it consistently they used to do
it back during like the 60s and 70s
every once in a while you will for
example in the Ultimate Universe when
Obama won the presidency in 2008 there
was a issue of Miles Morales that had
Obama on the front cover right so it's
like okay this is when this takes place
and occasionally they will you know
depending on what goes on Jonathan
Hickman indirectly does this in the
X-Men and the reason why is because what
this does is it initially picks up in
Davos Switzerland with the world
economic Forum which is a real world
event but the title of this particular
form is basically globalization for a
new age how to secure and maintain a
cohesive and sustainable world now for
the world economic Forum that's
happening in 20 20 which is to say it's
happening at the end of January the name
for that one is stakeholders for a
cohesive and sustainable world right so
we know that Hickman is largely
borrowing the name from the current
world economic Forum so we know that
this comic seems to take place right
about now it's a little fun Easter egg
but the entire basis behind why this
this world economic forum is happening
is because of krakowa one thing to bear
in mind here is that with cocoa
providing all these different medicines
and things like that they can prolong
people's lives they can cure mental
illness things like that these are forms
of medicine that simply didn't exist in
the world they did in some places for
example like wakanda had that kind of
stuff but as most of you guys know in
the comics wakanda doesn't really share
its resources with the rest of the world
and so because of that it's one of these
things worker Co has now popped up and
is in a lot of ways a concern for World
economic leaders because what you have
here is a scenario where in a lot of
ways the entire economic aspect of the
pharmaceutical industry could be
completely upheaved and completely
destroyed by wakakoa has to offer
because if gracola is saying we'll
provide these medicines and then in turn
you have pharmaceutical companies who
can't live keep up and can't provide the
same kinds of medicines people will go
to Cocoa right though they'll try to get
their medicine through cocoa cocoa has
your cure right so you'll go through
them and you won't go through existing
pharmaceutical companies this and the
fact that Krakow is positioning itself
to be its own individual Nation with its
own governing body is also a concern for
a lot of people because what you have is
this scenario where mutants still aren't
truly being trusted right they're still
not really really trusted by Humanity as
a whole and Humanity's fear is that what
kakoa is doing is basically
consolidating the mutant population I.E
marshalling their forces getting ready
to go to war and initially that wasn't
the case but after the the attempted
assassination of Charles Xavier now has
become a topic for a legitimate
legitimate discussion here and so what
you end up getting here is essentially
Cyclops Magneto Charles Xavier
apocalypse and Gorgon Gorgon is a
character that I don't really think
we've talked about before and his name
is Tomi shishito technically he's a
mutant but he's also well really he's
part of the hand and had been for a
little while his powers are kind of
split in two different factions right so
you've got his original mutant powers
and then you've got his powers that were
given to him when he was resurrected by
the hand super strength super speed
durability things like that a lot of
that really really all of that came from
the hand his mutant Powers were things
like empathy telepathy the ability to
basically turn people to Stone by
looking at them like Medusa that was
really his initial or his original
mutant ability and that's why you see
him here the other reason why he's here
is because if you notice you do have
apocalypse who's a pretty heavy hitter
the true diplomats here are Magneto and
Xavier so you've got Cyclops you've got
apocalypse and you got Gorgon who are
The Heavy Hitters who could basically do
whatever needed to be done if things
went down and really apocalypse was a
one-man Army all you really need is him
but getting in here it's not designed to
be like a like a like a Strike Team
right they're not here to launch an
assault they're here to be diplomatic
Magneto delivers this speech at the end
which is like one of the most amazing
things ever dude it's so awesome but
like can we just take a second to look
at like Magneto with like his white suit
right like he's got this this white suit
with like a like a purple shirt and a
red tie and like his white hair he just
looks boss it's also kind of weird to
see Apocalypse in a suit the real
question you have to ask here is is he
wearing an actual suit or did he modify
his body to make it look like he was
wearing a suit that's the question you
have to ask I'm kind of curious but
notice this for the most part this is a
pretty cordial Affair they're basically
being invited to dinner to kind of have
this sort of Round Table discussion
about how krakowa fits into everything
but make no mistake while humans here
are being cordial fear is the overriding
theme of this entire dinner and the
reason why is because what you end up
doing is you end up jumping to this
Revelation that there are strike teams
in the building there are teams that
have been tasked for the purpose of one
being able to block telepathic attack
right by having these kind of
modifications applied to their minds and
two they're there to take out the mutant
threat or at least that seems to be the
case and right off the bat Xavier picks
up on this right and that's a smart
thing to do that's the thing you would
have to expect Xavier to do right Xavier
would not just walk into a building and
be totally oblivious as to what's going
on in that building especially after
this attempted assassination and so with
that being the case or really I guess
successful assassination and his
resurrection with that being the case of
course he can't read their mind so he
doesn't know what their intentions are
but let's be honest you've got guys with
guns who are basically inside that base
and no none of the X-Men are supposed to
know that they're there obviously
they're there with some measure of ill
intent and so in turn psycho is warned
and he's basically told hey man be aware
these guys are here will you go take
care of them and it's kind of a funny
thing because of course the you know
Cyclops tells one of the guards about
that whole mutants acting on good
behavior and all that kind of stuff
there's been a bit of a change here and
so from there what you end up doing is
you jump into this discussion between uh
the various representatives of krakowa
and the human the humans who are there
now this is hugely important and this is
one of those aspects of Jonathan Hickman
writing that I've told you guys about
where you have to pay attention right
where this will become important much
later on down the line because if you
look at what's happening in X-Force
right if you look at the X-Force comic
whereby humans basically launched his
first strike at us it's time for us to
return in kind and then you look at this
this amounts to battle formations is
really how this is this is the beginning
of the human mutant war and so this
initially kicks off of the question
what's the end game here what's the goal
of krakowa that's kind of the question
that's being asked and the reality of
this is a somewhat of an unfair question
over the years like when you look at any
particular nation in the United States
or you look at Britain or you look at
France or Italy or Spain or any of those
they really kind of came to their
current form by virtue of just multiple
conflicts but it wasn't as though there
was an end goal right it wasn't as
though like when Rome was was founded in
the very beginning it's at this point in
time we are going to achieve this place
you know in like 2020. this is the end
goal of where we want to be the idea of
the the nation island of cocoa being
founded was to just provide a safe haven
for the mutant population and so when
the questions asked if the in-game here
is for you guys to just make your own
your own country then one we can't
ignore the amount of economic
destabilization your country's creating
and two we can't ignore the fear of
cocoa basically being not being an
island for mutants and then us not
really knowing what's going on and so at
the end of the day the wakanda
representative really makes a good point
in simply saying every nation will act
in its own self-interest it's what it
does every nation exists in such a way
to ensure its own sovereignty some
Nations will act with a more imperialist
stance which is to say trying to spread
their sphere of influence outside their
own country but at the end of the day
it's to ensure their own sovereignty If
you eliminate all the threats that are
out there then there's nobody there to
challenge you nobody there to pose a
danger to you and so as a result of that
of course you know when the questions
asked by Magneto one does wakanda want
to have some kind of a formal
relationship with krakowa then what kind
of is like no we're good you're gonna
have to keep doing your own thing and
wakanda can do that wakanda is the most
technologically advanced nation in the
world they're Way Beyond everybody else
in terms of medicine right so wakanda
doesn't really need anything grecoa has
to offer but remember wakandas opens
itself up to the world it's now on a
grand stage so wakanda is really kind of
out there doing its own thing and it
doesn't really need anything else the
world has to offer well then the
question becomes if crico is going to be
a place where mutants can celebrate
their Heritage and their culture then
why are you hiding from the world to
which apocalypse immediately responds
does this look like we're hiding if we
were hiding we wouldn't be here we
wouldn't come to this economic Summit
you know we wouldn't be here to talk to
you guys we would have just declined
your offer and continue doing whatever
it was that we were doing now kind of
the background here this is kind of a
subplot that goes on it's basically
Cyclops really by himself going through
and taking out all these various forces
of course gorgon's there as well but
Cyclops is doing the brunt of the work
right taking out these various henchmen
different things like that and it's kind
of a cool little scenario because from
there the various Representatives here
did exactly what the X-Men knew they
were going to do which was try to
reverse engineer the various medicines
that gracoa is supplying and one of the
questions they had is is it really
necessary to take these these medicines
on a daily regimen like is it necessary
to do that and the response to Magneto
is yes because the way that we've
engineered this is it has a cascading
effect right so you take the pill one
day and it starts to impact your body
but eventually it'll fade but as you
continually take this medicine it'll
build on top of itself eventually
achieving that goal but the reason for
why these pills are necessary for
long-term use will be explained at the
end of the story because it's absolutely
genius and so at that point it's just
kind of like okay so like at the end of
the day how should we interpret cocoa
like are you guys a threat or are you
guys not a threat and the way that my
needle answers this is actually pretty
smart he basically says well you
interpret us as a threat because you're
afraid of anything that you're not
familiar with anything that you don't
fully understand but like any other
Nation out there you're just going to
have to assume that our goal is to not
destroy you eventually like treaties
will be signed and things along those
lines but for the most part every nation
that exists out there is operating in
some measure on a good faith effort in
the world of nuclear proliferation is
okay well let's just hope you decide not
to push the button one day that's really
what it all comes down to you know the
hope that some dictator doesn't lose
their mind press the button and then
suddenly nuclear bombs get launched
somewhere and so as a result of that
Magneto basically says like you believe
this because of your history as Humanity
at this moment right now you're teaching
you're you're teaching your children in
schools to unlearn history and to
rewrite it in the way that you want it
to be history is written by the Victor
and he asks things he says like do you
guys know why you know how it is that
medieval societies got LED it's because
they mined it from Roman ruins but all
this knowledge was lost during the Dark
Ages all this stuff is gone you guys
don't know your own history and if the
history doesn't really seem to agree
with the narrative that you want to put
out there then you rewrite history
that's the nature of humanity that's
what you guys consistently do you change
the facts to suit your narrative and so
at the end of the day it's just kind of
like you know okay well when they start
talking about things like the collapse
of the Bronze Age Humanity's question is
like well why should we concern
ourselves with the collapse of the
Bronze Age an apocalypse says I was
alive then and you should be concerned
and they say well you know then tell us
if you were alive then what caused the
Great collapse and Taco says I was the
one who caused it so it's like oh you're
talking about some pretty Heavy Hitters
here like it's a pretty awesome moments
right apocalypse seemingly bringing down
society and the Bronze Age
which is kind of crazy but it's kind of
interesting you know because at this
point where they're kind of beating
around the bush now it's the full on
core question that's really been kind of
lingering on everybody's mind this
entire time should we be concerned about
war and Magneto's response this this is
this is why Jonathan Hickman writes
villains so well dude because he man he
he does it so well this part by by
Magneto is amazing he says no there will
not be any war and when Humanity says is
that so Manito says yes it is like it is
true there will not be any War like can
you can you not see that we as mutants
have essentially changed take me for
example in the past I would have taken
all your weapons of war all your guns
your tanks your bombs and I would have
turned them on you and he would have
right we've seen him do that multiple
times during the during the Fatal
Attraction story Magneto issued a
blanket EMP across the world that took
down power to the planet so this is not
something that would be totally
impossible or uncommon for him to do you
also get this cool little moment here
where Cyclops is facing off against
these guys and one of them has a gun and
is going to shoot him Xavier is
basically linking everybody together and
he says hey can I get a little to help
and like sitting at the dinner table
five floors above Magneto uses his
powers and rips the gun out of the guy's
hand and it's just like damn man but
then like you basically get this this
amazing thing he says basically we as
mutants we're gonna do what you as
Humanity do except we're gonna do it
better we're gonna give people a better
life than what you can give them we're
gonna give Humanity a better life than
what you and your government can do
we're gonna give them longer and
healthier existences and then we're
going to take the money the outrageous
amount of money that you're going to pay
us because at the end of the day it
means more money for you right the
governments buy drugs from cocoa and
then the governments sell those drugs to
the people for a profit of sorts like
we're going to take this outrageous
amount of money that you're going to
give us and then we're going to buy your
Banks and then we're gonna buy your
schools and then we're gonna buy your
media and then we're gonna buy your
politicians and then when we have bought
all the rest we're going to buy you
because you as Humanity has taught have
taught us as mutants by virtue of
turning us into slaves things like that
by persecuting us that everybody has
their price and so once we have this
influence once we have essentially
economic control of the world then we're
going to make sure that the Raw long
kind of people and you know who they are
will not be able to have any sort of
economic power whatsoever we will not
allow them into our institutions we will
not allow them to to Peddle their
outdated and dangerous ideologies and
that's how your entire control of the
world is going to end like fire without
oxygen it's just going to Peter out it's
just going to sort of disappear and he
says yes of course there are going to be
people who are going to disagree with us
yes there are going to be people who are
going to hate us that's fine they just
won't be able to do anything about it
anymore and it's like damn like we're
basically going to take your entire
world out from under you that's
literally what he says that's the goal
of cocoa to buy everything in the world
to basically take away any control you
have on your planet and essentially we
will control everything we will decide
what kind of education you guys get it's
absolutely genius right because it's a
war that's won without any real fighting
it's a war that's one by virtue of just
saying like we're in turn going to take
over the world by requiring you to be a
part of what we do that's why cocoa is
releasing these medicines that require
multiple regimens right taking it
multiple times because what it does is
it turns people into slaves or servants
to this medication it's the nature of
people once we cross that path we never
want to go back right we never want to
go back to the way things work if we
enjoy what we have now more than what we
had before and so because of that what
it does is it switches over to gorgon
and this is one of the coolest things
Gorgon is basically talking to these
guys after having chopped off all of
their arms he basically talks to them
and tells them you know in years past I
would have killed all of you but I think
it's more important that you spend your
lives living with your failure that you
guys understand things are different now
if you guys believe that the mutant
population is going to roll over that's
not the way it is anymore and so with
all of this having being said by Magneto
being said by gorgon and so on that in
turn Magneto chimes in and says you're
keeping your finger on your ear an awful
lot so let me go ahead and solve this
problem for you they're not coming the
forces that you have around here they're
not coming and that's when he basically
spills the beans because nobody else
knew about it that's when he basically
spills the beans and says we know about
the strike teams that you had in the
building they've been neutralized and
there's no real way for them to kind of
combat that and say well yeah we have
the strike teams there to kill you but I
mean you know why did you take them out
like that's not fair you know it doesn't
really work that way and so in at the
end of the day Humanity especially the
United States is kind of stuck with on
their face because it's sort of like
you're the one that sort of initiated
this we've taken those guys out they're
no longer no longer part of the equation
anymore and so from there you basically
end up having Xavier who removes this
mask of course letting us see his face
really for one of the first times as
part of a house of X powers of X and
Dawn of X and in turn he says is it
really necessary for you to fear Us in
such a way you're going to have to trust
us now you're going to have to trust our
nation you're going to have to believe
that we want to be Sovereign that we
want to be able to do our own thing so
we don't really want to make slaves out
of you but at the end of the day if
that's what it comes down to then that's
exactly what we will do but understand
this and this is one of the most
important things when they get up and
they begin to leave Xavier says
understand this and have no Illusions
Magneto says we've had fantastic
teachers in all of you you as humans
have taught us valuable lessons and what
it means to be persecuted and what it
means to be cast off and what it means
to do whatever it takes in order to
survive and so as a result of this you
guys struck first you guys launched an
attack on krakowa and you guys
assassinated or tried to assassinate
Charles Xavier kind of maintaining that
sort of that sort of lie the mission was
not a success but you guys struck first
understand if it happens again expect a
response we will bring the fight to your
doorstep and that's a scary proposition
because in Apocalypse alone he's enough
to essentially wipe the United States
out of existence right if the guy wanted
to he'd grow to 3000 feet tall and just
walk across the entirety of the United
States just spraying energy beams
everywhere and incinerating entire
cities that's the kind of power you have
and that's just apocalypse that's not
taking into account Magneto who can
totally disrupt the electromagnetic
polls that's not taking into account
Xavier who can scramble the minds of
everybody on Earth that's not even
taking into account the reality warpers
right so you've got Legion who's
floating out there somewhere you've got
Clinton choir who's an Omega Level
telepath that you got Emma Frost you got
all these huge Heavy Hitters that just
with about 10 of them could successfully
conquer the world like that and then
when you take the rest of the entirety
of the Newton population on percoa and
you add them to that Humanity stands no
chance and that's why this if anything
is the most terrifying aspect to
humanity this is how the war starts
because it's not it doesn't really start
by virtue of a shot why it doesn't
really start by virtually like a pot
shot that is kind of the initial
confrontation it starts with fear it
starts with a legitimate concern that if
the mutant population wanted to they
could bring the entire world down on its
knees and just leave it to burn
okay so we are picking back up again
with New Mutants and we're in part four
now if you guys recall the previous
Studio that we did on the New Mutants
what you basically had is you had uh
armor who would essentially grab the
glob and uh and Maxime and Manon and had
gone forward for the purpose of trying
to find Beacon Angel two of their former
teammates who decided not to show up on
krakowa and we ended up learning that
beak's father was basically dying and
the result was that when armor had
brought forth some medicines that could
be used to basically cure the father of
beak that in turn led to a whole bunch
of gunmen showing up on the doorstep of
of beak's home just say like like we
didn't really know what their intention
was we just knew they were just kind of
being dicks and so what we end up
learning are a couple things one the
leader of this group his name is as
cumulo and second they're here for the
purpose of trying to acquire more
medicines now of course taking everybody
out and really you know putting power
harnesses around everyone this basically
leads to what's kind of an interesting
bit of a story but also to me though
basically becoming what he hates and the
reason why is because what this does is
it tells us that on the island of Costa
perdida which is where tumulo's from or
at least cumulo and the rest of his
group are from that their country at
least their their land was really the
victim of essentially dumping right like
like dumping uh hazardous materials by
various corporations and the result was
that what it did is it led to this
massive amount of infection by about you
know for about 8 500 people now the
result of this is that there were
various medicines that were available
right like curcumin medicines or at
least cures that were being offered by
the government didn't really seem to be
from cocoa and instead of being able to
like give them out freely and saying hey
look here you guys go you know all that
kind of good stuff instead they were
being charged a thousand bucks a pop and
so as a result of that what it basically
did is it led to this kind of debate or
this kind of discussion or I guess you
know argument of sorts between the
government and pharmaceutical companies
that led to like more people dying while
all this was going on now the funny
thing about this is that armor chimes in
and says well then just like tell your
government to recognize Krakow as a
Sovereign Nation and Xavier and all them
will give you all the medicines for free
right but the issue with this is that
one the guy who was in charge of the
pharmaceutical company named uh named
Kevin McKinnon has been killed right
assumingly tumulo and the rest of his
guys basically killed this off now this
is an important thing to understand is a
tumulo does not directly say that he was
the one that killed the guy he just says
it's been taken care of now a couple
things to also keep in mind here is that
while this agreement was being worked
out with the federal government that
ultimately the death toll kept Rising
right and by the time an agreement was
reached 20 000 people had died and 65
000 were probably about 45 000 were left
infected out of the 65 000 that had been
been infected in total but the issue is
that at the moment these you know this
these medicines at least the need for
these medicines in these trying times
are still a theme that's there but the
funny thing about this is that when you
end up talking to or at least when when
tumulose talking to armor you know where
she basically again kind of brings up
this point we'll have Charles Xavier
gonna have your country you know
basically side with cocoa and you'll get
free medicines his response is no I'm
not going to ask him to do that because
if they do there goes my profit margin
so essentially what this guy is doing is
in turn getting medicine from the
government after this deal has worked
out and now he's basically playing the
role of Kevin McKinnon and it's just
kind of like okay so like what in the
heck then like this guy's basically as
bad as the guy that he just gunned down
and it's kind of one of these things
where like this cycle always repeats
itself right you know and he really kind
of makes this point in saying that where
they're suffering there's opportunity
which is a pretty terrible philosophy to
have to be honest but at the end of the
day what it does is it switches over to
Sage and to end a boom boom now the
funny thing about boom boom and this
might be more of a controversial point
but the funny thing about boom boom is I
don't think she's really been relevant I
don't think Tabitha Smith has really
been a relevant character since her days
on X Factor I mean she had a she had a
stint on next wave in the mid-2000s she
had some involvement in the New Mutants
different things like that but she she
never really seemed to achieve the same
kind of relevance she had when she was
brought into the old X4 stories by Rob
liefeld and so because of that seeing
her here and playing somewhat of a
significant role or playing somewhat of
an important role is kind of interesting
but it seems like Ed brison kind of
plays on this idea that she was just
kind of free-floating over the years
because she's basically a drunk right
she's just like drinking alcohol all the
time and just kind of partying and doing
her thing and just sort of having this
this you know attitude of whatever
happens happens and so when she goes to
visit stage of course she asks the
question where's armor and all them and
it's been about five days and Sage is
like well they haven't come back yet I'm
not their babysitter I don't know what
happened to him who knows it's actually
kind of an interesting start because
Sage for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with their character Sage I
wouldn't really say doesn't care about
people but like she's been assigned a
role and her mind in a lot of ways works
like a computer so it's not that she
doesn't really care about any of the
other X-Men or anything like that but
it's kind of once you leave the island
of kakoa what you do is on you and it's
none of my business it's none of my
concern you know if it's that important
somebody will stay on the alarm and
somebody will go out there and look for
you which is exactly what Tabitha is
doing that's kind of the nature of sage
right I mean she's not really a terrible
person she's just kind of doing her
thing and so what ends up happening here
is kind of switching back to Nebraska to
Milo tells armor look like here's what's
gonna happen you're gonna send forces or
you're gonna send people who can
negotiate right who can negotiate with
Xavier and basically say for for you
know if if you want any of these
hostages to live then like you're gonna
give us medicines we want one ton of
medicine for every hostage that we have
which is an outrageous request right
it's kind of a ridiculous request even
for like a situation like this like no
way it's going to be fulfilled but then
the questions asked by armor how did you
even know we were here in the first
place and this is when Ed brison really
starts to tie into kind of like the
grander picture with what's going on at
dawn of X and there's a few ways in
which he does this the first is my way
of tumula himself right when it came to
the idea that they were going to be
medicines out there provided by krakowa
that could cure virtually any illness
and provide longer life spans and any
kind of mental illness or anything like
that it was only a matter of time before
what you got were basically the rise of
like Petty Warlords and strongmen who
are going to try to like usurp control
in a particular region and then dominate
this Medical Market and decide who gets
it and who doesn't and kind of utilize
that as a means to control that region
at the same time what we also saw were
the rise of these various websites that
really came in two forms the first were
those websites that supported various
meetings who were out there and those
websites who didn't and their websites
out there who were keeping tabs on where
mutants were going and what they were
doing this is kind of the funny thing Ed
person almost ties into the old project
Wide Awake stories right you know the
old fall of mutant things that we saw
during Chris claremont's run you know we
have the picture of Franklin Richards
and it's like do you know where your
child is do you know if your child's
with mutants anything like that a lot of
that fear-mongering stuff that went on
you know like you need to be afraid
because you know if you're if you're
free then you'll do what we tell you to
and so following this what you do is you
pick up with a really cool scene with
Maxime and Manon now we haven't really
talked about their characters before and
they're actually relatively new they
appeared in the extinction event and the
way this played out is you you kind of
had a long-standing villain and Marvel
Comics named Ahab and Ahab was basically
this guy that had technological
components right he was a cyborg more or
less he doesn't have a huge stint like
you don't see him all the time you see
him periodically and he does little
things here and there and so on and so
forth but the idea behind this is that
Maxime and Manon during the uh during
the extinction event were basically two
mutants who were who manifested their
powers at a younger age and so they were
brought to the Xavier Institute but five
years after that happened they were
kidnapped by Ahab and they were taken to
the Future so Ahab could basically have
them create hounds the overall idea here
is that the hounds of Ahab were very
similar to the hounds of like Days of
Future Past and so far that during that
point in time uh where a lot of you guys
and a lot of you guys probably asked
this right like in Days of Future Past
how did Sentinels find humans so or find
mutants so fast they used hounds right
hounds were in where mutants who had
like telepathy or empathy or in some
form or fashion were able to locate
mutants and then in turn were bred and
they were kind of tortured and their
minds were warped and they were used for
the purpose of tracking down those
various mutants the hounds that they
have were very similar to that but the
reason why Maxime and Manon were so
important is because you using their
powers together they could Dominate and
control the minds of others and turn
them into the hounds that Ahab wanted
and so that's kind of where their
significance came from now ultimately
once that reality was was kept from
coming to fruition when cable basically
traveled back to stop that reality's
existence and so on and so forth Maxim
and Manon ended up traveling back into
the main Marvel Universe and that's how
they end up here but these characters
are really powerful in a couple
different ways and the reason why is
because Angel basically tells Andre one
of the the guys that are holding them
hostage you know we my kids can't ingest
this food this way you know I can
basically you know take this food in and
then I can feed it to them much in the
same way that a female bird or I guess a
mom bird would feed you know her her
Offspring and then when she injects it
she spits out this kind of corrosive
acid which basically disables the the
collar of Maxime who in turn grabs Andre
now this is where the powers come into
play and the reason why is because
individually what they can do is they
can tap into others and they can
manipulate their emotions right they can
kind of instill these little thoughts
things like that and so when she sees
his control of Andre what she says is
your cohort you remember like when you
came home and your cohort was sleeping
with your wife and then he shot all your
you know shot your parents up and kill
them kind of putting these subliminal
thoughts these false false thoughts in
the mind of the sky which in turn leads
him to going insane and then when you
have uh have man in the jumps in and he
kind of does the same thing then
basically all hell starts to break loose
now at that point like Angel and
everybody starts to panic because what
you have are these guys you have one guy
who's on the defensive you have another
guy who's basically you know reliving
these false memories and then they have
guns point at each other right so this
is an entire shootout that could go on
and anybody could get caught in the
crossfire which is pretty dangerous now
a lot of this goes into the dangerous
nature of of Maxine and Manon insofar as
because of the fact that they were kind
of Twisted and they were sort of screwed
up while some of those evil elements
have been removed they tend to kind of
get caught up in the moment and they
don't think about the best course of
action and so as a result of that what
ends up happening here is of course fire
ends up breaking out between these two
guys or at least you know gunfire ends
up breaking out between these two guys
and of course two Milo's like what the
heck is going on at that point there's
an explosion and we're basically met
with the arrival of Tabitha Tabitha
Smith who used her little plasma bombs
to blow the whole thing up all the while
she's standing there drinking some
whiskey
Tabitha Smith has problems
okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and you're gonna have to bear with me on
this uh with regards to probably some
Echo maybe some background noise uh I am
in Columbus now and uh I am not really
in a sound treated space so I'm just
kind of in a kitchen
recording this audio so uh yeah anyway
so we're picking up with X-Men issue
number five right we still need to kind
of get back into the swing of things you
know cover like X-Force and Excalibur
and all that kind of stuff and and we'll
get back into that but for right now uh
we're taking it relatively easy this
week and we're gonna cover X-Men issue
number five now what this does and this
is something that I kind of need to
clarify in previous videos I feel like I
was confusing Children of the Vault with
children of tomorrow and I probably was
the children of tomorrow were from the
Ultimate Universe right and we covered
that during Jonathan Hickman's uh what
is it the ultimate so we covered that
you'll find the link to that down in the
description it's not super important to
this video just kind of clarifying
things but the idea was a read Richard's
at least Ultimate Universe read Richards
had constructed a city that basically
allowed time to pass differently and the
result was that what this did is it
created a kind of space whereby he could
essentially create life watch that life
evolve with rapid acceleration right so
time pass totally different in that area
with this with the the children of the
Vault that was Mike Carey back in 2006
right now really you have the what was
called the the Supernova storyline that
really kind of introduce the children of
the Vault back in X-Men Volume 2 issue
number 198 I think it was and uh and
basically we we kind of got this little
bit of a story with him and then they
were almost never referenced again after
that right now a lot of that was because
of what jokasada and and all those guys
were doing you know like like Rick
reminder and Craig Kyle and Chris Yost
and uh Ed Brubaker and all those guys
really kind of like reworking the X-Men
Mythos Post House of him and so because
that it was kind of like all right so
let's just kind of see what happens and
so it was really focusing more on
reducing the population of mutants and
then focusing on on those particular
stories but for Mike Carey's supernova's
event what we ended up finding out was
that somewhere along the line there was
this this giant space much like what we
saw later on with Jonathan Hickman's
ultimate there was basically this kind
of City this sort of Vault that was
constructed and time passed differently
in the vault and it basically allowed
individuals who were allowed you know
allowed kind of a creation of these
children and the idea behind this is
that these children would evolve over
the course of six thousand years it was
something along those lines basically
they would exit the vault at a time when
humans and mutants no longer existed on
Earth and they would basically be these
kind of post-humans that would basically
kind of take over the landscape the
result of this is that by the mechanism
of sabertooth and the house of immovan
itself they ended up being woken up
early and so when they did only five of
them showed up instead of the thousands
that were supposed to and you basically
got the Supernova storyline now for how
this pertains to this what we end up
doing here is picking up with a girl
named Seraphina now Seraphina was one of
the children of the Vault and really the
most notable in the supernovas event
because the kind of power she possessed
right she demonstrated the ability to
dominate the minds of others she was
also able to Shield herself from
telepathic detection as well as cerebro
right so she was basically invisible to
the mental eye I'm pretty sure it was a
naked eye as well but nobody really knew
that she was inside the the X-Men
mansion but uh what we end up having
here is basically Seraphina who's
essentially running for her life after
you know basically having been
discovered during the original House of
X and powers of X story with the the
orchestra basis and so on and so forth
and having somehow managed to arrive
back here on Earth and then basically
taking off that you know she's fleeing
for life and then takes over the minds
of a couple people and basically says
stop that man from chasing me only for
us to find out that it's Wolverine right
now the reason why this matters is
because the children of the Vault are as
much an enigma to the X-Men as anything
else and so while the X-Men do view them
as a credible threat they almost they
also know almost nothing about them
except for the fact that whenever they
leave the Vault it's always done in
groups and that's basically it they
don't really know anything about the
children of the Vault and it's kind of a
desire to understand what's going on as
well as determine whether or not they're
a credible threat and so the result of
this is that of course these guys run up
on Wolverine Wolverine doesn't really
kill him he just kind of incapacitates
them and then goes on the hunt for the
girl only for her to enter the Vault and
initially when when this story was
released I was looking through the issue
I didn't really know I recognized
Seraphina but I didn't really know what
all was going on here and it's not until
Wolverine basically chimes in with the
X-Men and asks are you guys still there
and it's like yes we're here and it's
like she took off into the Vault like we
can't find it right we can't trace we
can't track her and we can't go in there
now the reason why this is important is
because the Vault does have a physical
seal right it does have a physical
entrance but it also has a timeshare
basically meaning if you don't if your
body doesn't exist to the resident hum
more or less like if it doesn't really
match the access code to get into the
ball then essentially it could kill you
right it could it could destroy you and
so you kind of have to be designed or
engineered in such a way to where you
can enter the Vault right so it's like
knowing the passcode to be able to get
in and so because of that what the X-Men
basically need are a group of people who
can adapt to pretty much any
circumstance and then enter into the
Vault itself now one other thing to
point out here is that this vault is
basically housed by a gigantic Sentinel
now the reason why this matters is
because this is essentially Master mode
but it's not just any Master Mold it's
the wild Master Mold now this is one of
the reasons why Jonathan Hickman's X-Men
run is so cool because it really kind of
TAPS into a lot of the things that were
going on now the reality of this is that
with this giant Vault more or less this
giant Sentinel this was part of my
Carriage Run right this is where the the
children of the Vault basically
retreated to once it was all said and
done but the the giant signal here this
this giant Master Mold is essentially a
wild Sentinel and this was introduced
during Grant Morrison's ES4 Extinction
storyline right with Cassandra Nova this
idea that somewhere along the line that
Bolivar Trask had basically engineered
these kind of wild experimental
Sentinels but they were never actually
used the Sentinels that existed in this
space on this island these wild
Sentinels they were used by Cassandra
Nova to wipe out 16 million mutants on
the island of genocia right so that's
where all that comes from this guy
mastermo was the one who was basically
engineering and creating them right just
kind of manufacturing these things now
as far as we're aware the master mold
isn't really functional anymore it's
just kind of a giant shell of a monster
and and the Vault kind of resides within
but what this does it really kind of
allows us to basically pick up with when
an approved organism enters into the
bowl and when it does the ball basically
scans them it says like do we recognize
you do we not recognize you if we
recognize you we welcome you as a friend
and you're able to enter the Vault
presumably if we do not recognize you
you're treated as an enemy and so what
it does is it jumps over to the X-Men
this is one of the things that's really
kind of important here because it sort
of establishes how the Vault works and
so far is time flowing differently now
we're not really given a ratio right
we're not really told for every two day
days that passes like a hundred years
pass inside the Vault right it's just
time passes differently totally
different from from the way time
normally works here you know outside of
the vault in the real world and so as a
result of that it's one of those things
where telepathy and none of the
technology of the X-Men can penetrate
The Vault but they need to know what's
going on inside of there and so what
they've done is they've assembled a
group they've assembled Darwin sync and
x23 now the reason why this is important
is because Darwin as a lot of you guys
probably know is a mutant whose ability
allows him to adapt to any situation
right so if you were to put them in a
pod and then just shoot him out into
space then his body would adapt to the
ability to breathe in space if you put
him under water his body would adapt to
the ability to breathe underwater which
coincidentally is actually how he first
discovers his powers uh it's one of
these things while you put him in a room
with toxic gas he'll develop the ability
to to basically filter that gas out of
his body and then survive in that that
you know particular space the guy is it
on Mega level mutant because of that
right there's no real conceivable way to
actually kill Darwin with that you also
have sync and sync is an old school
character right sync originally debuted
the old X-Men Volume 2 comics in the
early 1990s and then went on to become
one of the original members of
Generation X now when Generation X issue
number 70 he ended up dying and so he's
really been out of the landscape of
Marvel Comics since 2000 right so for
about 19 years he'd basically been gone
uh him being brought back as part of
those resurrections that were done by
the five right that's what Jonathan
Hickman has really been doing with the
five it's basically resurrecting all the
mutants who have died but but Hickman's
not really doing it arbitrarily he's
kind of staging it out right like you
know is there a reason for this mutant
to be here if there is resurrect them if
not leave him dead until we need them
and then we'll resurrect them right so
singer is a character who can basically
duplicate the powers of pretty much any
other mutants and then of course you've
got Laura Kinney x23 with her healing
factor and so because of this what
they're basically told is you guys have
all been chosen because you can all
adapt to pretty much any particular
Circumstance the the healing factor of
x23 would allow her to basically heal
from the time sheer right the idea of
the timeshear would try to cut off their
access she can kind of push her way
through it Darwin and sync can really
adapt you know sync can adapt to the the
powers of x23 so he can enter and then
Darwin can just automatically adapt to
whatever particular situation he needs
now the other part of this is that the
you know aside from Seraphina the other
five members of children of the Vault
are basically dead right like it seems
like you know for for the most part
pretty much everybody's dead but the
other four members are dead right so uh
Sangre pero uh I don't know if it was
aguya I'm not 100 sure how you pronounce
that that name and then Fuego they were
all basically dead except for Seraphina
she's the only one who's still there and
so with her basically returning it's
okay she's here you know she's basically
returned to the Vault now and then from
that point the Vault starts going
through and saying okay it's time to
start upgrading people you know from
there the Vault really kind of does
exactly what the X-Men have been doing
which is restoring those individuals who
have died and then in turn upgrading
them right so preparing them for this
new kind of threat that the X-Men seem
to represent and so what the X-Men do is
they launch an attack seemingly on two
fronts the first one is basically going
to serve the purpose of kind of being a
distraction the false defense system
will kick in when it recognizes a threat
and so the X-Men will show up and
they'll present themselves as a credible
threat The Vault will see them that way
and then the Vault will launch defense
mechanisms but what the Vault will do is
focus on them and not focus on the kind
of Wentworth team more or less right the
secret team and The Sims of x23 Darwin
and sync and so as they make their way
to that location they're able to of
course access and get into the Vault but
once they get inside the space the issue
they run into is of course all all
communication is basically cut off right
it's like it's like a closed biome in a
lot of ways the vault is akin to like a
different dimension right like if they
had entered into the dimension of Asgard
then like access to any really any real
telepathic connection from Xavier would
essentially be cut off right or like
traveling to a different universe or
something along those lines it really is
completely self-contained and completely
cut off from everything and everyone
else because by being a system that
basically uses a kind of time
manipulation basically means that it's
almost out of phase out of sync with the
existing main Marvel Universe the issue
with this is that once the the team
basically enters into the Vault then it
turns into okay the Vault sees them as a
credible threat right basically the
Vault has been quote unquote
contaminated it doesn't know who these
guys are it doesn't know what their
powers are and so it automatically
begins launching its defense system and
so what you end up having is much later
roughly about three months and five days
after the X-Men entered the Vault and
when they get in there if Cyclops starts
talking to uh what what looks like uh
Charles Xavier watching everything go
down and when he says like how long has
it been of course you know Xavier
whoever this is says you know three
months and five days and so how long has
it been inside of the Vault and it's
roughly 537 years have passed inside
that Vault now what this means is that
when it comes to these characters this
is actually a really really smart move
by Hickman if what Jonathan Hickman
wants to do is change the powers of of
x23 or change the powers of sync or
change the powers of Darwin right to
like Elevate them and make them more
powerful than they were before this is
the way to do it because what he would
basically say here is that they've
evolved it would just say over the
course of the last 500 years their
powers have evolved right so it's like
if they lived for 500 years in the real
world so over three months they probably
could have gotten stronger faster maybe
their powers are more potent maybe the
healing factor of x23 is more efficient
maybe uh the powers of Darwin are more
extreme and what he can and can't copy
maybe now it's molecular manipulation we
don't really know we won't really know
until they exit from The Vault but it's
kind of Cyclops sort of looking at him
yourself and saying what the hell was I
thinking by sending them in there
okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and I'm getting ready to crash out for
the night I am getting ready to go to
bed but before I do we are covering
X-Men part six
yes we are the conclusion of the X-Men
story or at least the first story arc of
X-Men by Jonathan Hickman so this is
pretty solid but what it does is it
requires us to kind of wind back to
house and powers of X right it all just
kind of wraps back around to the
beginning of everything and how it all
sort of started and the way this picks
up is it is it sort of jumps to the Past
right at some point in the past there
was a kind of discussion that took place
between uh Irene Adler and uh and
Mystique now for those of you guys who
don't know Irene Adler is also somebody
by the name of Destiny and you've
probably heard of what are called
Destiny's books or Destiny's diaries
that was part of an extreme X-Men story
from 2001 the hunt for Destiny's Diaries
which is actually pretty cool right this
idea that she wrote 13 books which
basically detailed what was going to
happen in the future but Irene Adler
originally appeared back in Uncanny
X-Men issue number 141 right so she was
basically introduced as part of the Days
of Future Past Saga and then from there
she was really kind of brought in as
essentially this love interest and wife
of Mystique where the two of them fell
in love the two of them had a
relationship and it was pretty solid
it's one of those things that only for
hardcore X-Men fans do you really know
about it it's really pretty obscure
right and even Destiny herself is pretty
obscure in relation to like the greater
comic book landscape but the long and
short of this is that she ultimately
ended up dying and Uncanny X-Men issue
number 255 basically the two of them
were always kind of uh like the one-two
punch of what was essentially the
Brotherhood of evil mutants in Marvel
Comics after the events of Magneto
basically leaving that in Freedom Force
what Destiny ends up saying is that
she's got something to tell Mystique
like I have something to tell you but
before we find out what it is we jump to
the here and now and what this shows us
is that work is still being done by
orcas now again for those of you guys
who are playing Ketchup from house and
powers of X and I highly suggest that
you guys go and check out my uh playlist
on the X-Men which you'll find down in
the description and it'll get you
totally caught up on pretty much
everything going on but orcas is kind of
like this anti High mutant organization
more or less that basically composes or
is or is composed of a lot of
organizations right so Hydra has a hand
in it um the let's see the advanced idea
mechanics groups has a has a hand in it
all kinds of different groups right the
only group that I do not believe is
involved in orcas are the purifiers
although I could be wrong but the
overall just behind this is that if you
guys recall in the events of house and
powers of x uh that the X-Men had
basically launched an attack against the
orcas Corporation in order to destroy
mother mold and mother mold was
basically a a giant Sentinel that was
going to produce master balls and master
moles in turn produce the regular
Sentinels that you guys are used to
seeing and what this would do or at
least what it would have done had it you
know been successful is it would have
led to the development of Sentinels at a
geometric rate right it would have just
been insane how fast the Sentinel
production would have been ramped up by
humanity and so in order to keep that
from happening and really kind of under
the information provided to them by
Mormon kagger due to the various lives
that she's lived over you know the 10
timelines whatever the case is uh she
ended up you know the X-Men end of
traveling to uh to orcas Corporation and
then in turn basically you know taking
out mother mold which you know letting
it crash into the Sun but also resulted
in all of their deaths right and so what
we end up having here is a guy by a guy
by the name of Dr Devo right or Dr Devo
you know however it is that you that you
want to pronounce it although I guess
this really director demo is really what
it is but anyway he's the guy overseeing
the whole orcas Corporation and of
course working on a device this device
is taken directly to Dr Greger now Dr
Greger if you guys recall was the woman
who lost her husband during the X-Men
strike on orchestration right so for her
it's not really about you know the
possibility of a mutant threat for now
for her it's now like a personal
Vendetta is really what it is right it's
a personal Vendetta against the X-Men
and so what we end up finding out here
at least the way things look is of
course she's kind of building this this
sort of uh this sort of chassis but
before we really find out what it is
what we end up doing is jumping back to
uh to the plans that were basically
being made with regards to mystique and
with Charles Xavier and the the mission
that was going to take place with
regards to Orchid space and now if you
guys again this is one of those
important stories because it kind of
bounces back and forth you know with
house and powers that Lex but the the
idea behind this is that when Xavier and
Company initially went to to mystique
and basically said like we want you to
be on this Mission but because we want
you to serve a particular purpose the
question was what is this purpose and
ultimately they said we want you to plan
a seat and so this is kind of some of
the behind the scenes stuff that we did
not initially see when we were reading
house and powers of X and remember
that's the nature of Jonathan Hickman
right Hickman will do a thing he'll
he'll write a part of a story and then
he'll leave part of it out right and
then like later on down the line you'll
figure out what that part of the story
was and why it's important right so
there can be a lot of bouncing around
and a lot of shuffling and things along
those lines but the idea was to plant a
seed seemingly a door a krakowan Gateway
on the ship that nobody was going to
know about and this is when we basically
ended up picking up with Mystique during
the events of house and powers of X when
she was killed right when she was
basically sucked out of an airlock and
it basically seemed to be the end of her
and it's kind of a funny thing because
then of course they basically pick up
with the resurrection of uh of Mystique
and then that's when she essentially
gets into the deal that was being made
right the idea that if she agreed to
work alongside Charles Xavier you're in
Magneto this would be given something in
turn and the question is what is it that
she was supposed to give right what is
it she was supposed to essentially get
you know as a result of working along
with them and it's one of these funny
things right because when they're
talking you know Xavier kind of says you
know uh basically like we're grateful
for everything that you've done but
ultimately we need more and that's
really kind of one of the the issues
that you get when it comes to Xavier and
Magneto in their current state is yes
they're operating on a greater Authority
that Authority coming from Warren
mctaggard who's basically said I've
experienced multiple timelines they all
into the same way this is the way for us
to change things that kind of stuff but
it also brings in a lot of humorous a
lot of arrogance right the whole we know
better than you do kind of attitude
which could really cause a lot of
problems especially when you're dealing
with somebody like Mystique because for
all the glitz and glamor and all the
talks they basically have Mystique is
one of the best people to bring in on
their side because she's lived for
hundreds of years right she's been she's
been around longer than Wolverine has
right so she's an exceedingly old
character but the idea is that she also
has a lot of experience under her belt
she's been a good guy she's been a bad
guy you know when she when she led
Freedom Force it was a U.S government
sanctioned team I like they basically
went out and saved mutants from
anti-mutant groups right it was it was
really done like in exchange for pardons
right you know for them to basically be
given pardons from their actions as a
Brotherhood because that's what Freedom
Force was just the reformed Brotherhood
of evil mutants uh but when they're
having this whole conversation what
they're basically doing at least the the
initial question of Mystique is okay if
this gate didn't work then what happens
if I try to walk through it right
because the issue is that she died
before her actions could be recorded by
cerebra right so if you guys recall what
Hickman's established here is that death
doesn't really exist anymore right any
Mutant that dies can be brought back and
it's not done for the purpose of just
being like oh we're over just is
whatever you know it's being done by
basically saying it serves a purpose
right there's a reason behind why this
happened but one of the things that's
been going on here is that with the the
X-Men or various mutants who are being
sent on missions their minds are always
backed up and so should they return from
that mission the information they have
is backed up in cerebro so the X-Men are
really the mutant population always has
an updated database on what's going on
around the world with the various
missions that are being undertaken and
things like that and so the result is
that with speak her mind was not backed
up before she died right so there was no
way to know if she had successfully
planted the device planted the Gateway
on cocoa and because it was such a
secret mission no one was supposed to
know about it right so it's not like you
know they can go to Jean Gray and say
hey like can you can you tell us whether
or not uh she planted that Gateway
because not even Gene gray knew that it
was going to be going on right like
nobody knew that this was being done by
Xavier Magneto through mystique and so
ultimately when she ends up you know
donning an outfit and passing through
she ends up finding out yes it worked
exactly like it was supposed to and
that's when she comes to the realization
of what's actually going on right the
idea here that was essentially been
taking place is that where it was
believed that the mother mold was
essentially going to create master mold
which in turn was going to create
Sentinels who in turn would create
nimrods ultimately that's not what
happened but instead nimrods were
manufactured by humans directly they
were created explicitly by human beings
they were not created by Sentinels and
that was the big error that was being
discovered here right the idea that
Nimrod is is essentially being designed
and and isn't really functional yet but
will be and is functioning or at least
is being built on the orcus station so
humans are developing these Ultra
Sentinels right and it kind of makes
sense right it makes sense to kind of
create these Sentinels that are
virtually indestructible because that's
one of the things about Nimrod is Nimrod
has the ability to sense the inherent
weaknesses of the mutants he's facing
off again so then of course also you
know know what their powers are just by
tapping into the Sentinel database he
has a whole host of different abilities
right shape shifting different things
like that but he's one of the most
dangerous threats out there Nimrod is
exceedingly powerful and so that's one
of the big things is because when when
you end up having this go down they
initially try to get Mystique to go back
in and it basically you know destroy the
Nimrod program or whatever the case is
but her response is no and the reason
why is because she wants Destiny to come
back and that was the deal that was made
the deal that was made by Xavier and
Magneto is if you do this for us we'll
bring back Destiny and so ultimately
when Mystique tries to barter Misty
tries to get them to bring her back
ultimately they don't they're just kind
of like no like like you need to do for
us like we'll bring her back once you've
earned it right like once you've earned
the right to have have Destiny return to
you then it will be done and that's why
we end up that's that's where we end up
jumping into the conversation between
Destiny and Mystique right and this is
probably one of the single most
important things to go on here what
Destiny basically says is she says you
know sometime you know sometime in the
future I'm going to die right like I'm
going to die prematurely before I grow
old or anything like that you know I'll
die before old age takes me but there
will also come a point many years after
that or there will be an island right
and on this island there will be mutants
who are who are inhabiting there and and
they will make a deal with you in order
to bring me back but ultimately they're
never going to hold true to their deal
right they're going to do everything
they can to deny you my return right
like in order for this you know in in
this instance when this time comes like
what I want you to do is to bring me
back right like bring me back do not let
me stay dead right like bring me back
because the the ultimate idea is that
those individuals want us to be blind
they want us to be blind and and to
follow their plan without any question
whatsoever what this does is it hits the
idea and we don't really know whether
are not you know Destiny's being
nefarious here there's really no reason
to believe she is what she's basically
establishing here is the idea that
Charles Xavier and Magneto are
essentially you know well of course
they're being dubious by being
mysterious but they're not really
looking out for the overall betterment
of mutant kind well that's not really
what they're shooting for there's some
kind of alternative plan going on here
presumably the mutant population could
be used as cannon fodder and whatever
happens to them happens today but having
a precognitive like Destiny show up on
the scene would essentially disrupt all
their plants because Destiny's well
known to the mutant population right and
even to the world population Shield
knows who she is The Avengers know who
she is everybody know who knows who
Destiny was right and so with that being
the case when she shows back up if she
shows back up immediately her
precognitive abilities are going to be
recognized as for the most part absolute
and if she comes along and she says guys
everything that you've been told is
wrong here's what's actually going to
happen people will listen to her and
they'll really kind of begin ignoring
Charles Xavier and Magneto which can
cause all kinds of problems right so the
return of Destiny could be cool but it
could also will cause some crazy things
to take place
okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and uh we're getting back into dawn of X
and I know it's been a little while
since we covered dawn of X stuff
honestly like with Swan and everything
and with moving and all that kind of
stuff it's kind of become a little bit
of a it became a little bit chaotic for
for a while but I'm finally in here um I
think I'm gonna do a live stream where
I'm like painting my office doing things
like that just kind of way to interact
and talk with you guys but uh but we're
getting into really kind of finishing up
the first volume of New Mutants now this
one's a little weird this first volume
quote unquote runs about nine issues or
as most traditional volumes run about
six and the reason why is because we've
actually kind of got two stories being
told here at the same time now for those
of you guys who are are looking to catch
up on anything you'll find my playlist
to the X-Men down in the description
there's all kinds of videos there about
like characters like Nightcrawler Rogue
Magneto all those characters explained
different things like that kind of
giving you their backstories publication
histories to making an expert on them
and then in addition to that we have
house and powers of X and what we did is
we kind of went through and kind of
pruned the playlist right it's one of
the things we talked about so sort of
bear with me here for a second but we
essentially pruned the playlist and so
far that if it was not referenced by
Jonathan Hickman in house and powers of
X we didn't put it in there and the
reason why was just because of the fact
that that at that point you know there's
so much this happened in the X-Men's
history we kind of have to rely on what
it is that Marvel's doing and this this
really kind of still ongoing reboot um
in order to decide what needs to say and
what doesn't right so that playlist
would change all the time the meat and
potatoes of this is that up to this
point really with the the first group of
New Mutants with uh Sunfire and magic
and all these characters they'd
essentially gone into space for no other
reason than to rescue Sam Guthrie right
because Sam was one of the original New
Mutants and the idea was to get the
original team back together again right
so that was the whole just behind it
what they ended up kind of running into
were some some issues with the star
Jammers and so on and so forth and what
it did is it landed them here where they
had to escort death we'll talk about her
here in a second the other part of the
story dealt with uh the the efforts of
armor to basically go and grab Vic who
was really more of a newer member of the
New Mutants who had essentially gone
missing before the events of the
formation of krakowa and like kind of
the safe haven for the mutant population
so we really actually kind of to pick up
with with gladiator himself now one
thing to bear in mind here is that
gladiator has kind of been the magistrix
or the leader of the shiar empire for
quite some time and really since the
defeat of Vulcan right to kind of follow
this timeline a little bit when the
shiar empire was first introduced in
Marvel Comics The Leader at the time was
a guy named de Kent and the Ken was
really on the hunt for the mkron crystal
that was really a big part of the
Phoenix and the dark Phoenix sagas
really the Phoenix Saga more than
anything else but following the defeat
of the Ken his sister La landremani took
his place and she was the longest
running leader of the Shia Empire in
Marvel Comics until the events of uh
X-Men deadly Genesis the introduction of
Vulcan the third Summer's brother the
Omega Level mutants that went into like
war of kings and that kind of a thing
but once he was defeated then Gladiator
in turn took his place and so Gladiator
was the leader of the shiar Empire
during like Jonathan Hickman's Avengers
and New Avengers and all that kind of
stuff during the era of the X-Men
essentially running everything after the
war of Kings right so from 2010 to about
2015-16 or so it was it was Gladiator
and even up until about this and the
reason why that's changed is because
Gladiator is no longer the leader of the
Shia instead it's essentially the
daughter of lalondra now what this does
is it leads to him essentially tasking
Oracle or really kind of asking the
question you know how far are we are we
on the mission of like you know
basically getting uh death bird back
here because death bird was previously
in Exile and she's gonna play kind of a
big role here but Oracle herself who's
really sort of this psychic that always
always kind of worked as like the right
hand of the Oracle ends up meeting with
his super clandestine group now the
death Commandos as they're introduced
here are essentially Marvel's version of
The Suicide Squad right in the sense
that in DC Comics The Suicide Squad is a
team it's basically sent in for Black
Ops missions and they're they're
Expendable right if one of them dies
somebody else takes their place and
there's really no mourning them or
having a great big huge military funeral
or anything like that it's just the
nature of the business with the death
Commandos these are a wholly new
introduction by Jonathan Hickman and
it's actually a cool idea and the reason
why is because the death Commandos are
basically one of these groups that are
intentionally designed to go on suicide
missions their leader is black cloak and
black cloak is really the only instance
where that roll always stays the same
the person that plays Black cloak may
change but is always a black cloak that
leads the death Commandos now these are
guys who are basically tasked with
achieving their mission by any means
necessary and so it's almost kind of
like you know here in the real world
where like you have the CIA right the
CIA is the intelligence gathering
apparatus of the United States focusing
on everything outside of the us where
the FBI focuses on everything inside the
states but the CIA also has involvement
with some pretty seedy groups that are
out there that cannot officially exist
you know if they're ever caught then
they'd basically be disavowed and the
government would you know deny any
knowledge of their existence that kind
of a thing that's how this works with
the death Commandos but basically
they're being tasked with taking out
death burden so essentially oracle's
working directly against the Shia Empire
here so it's kind of a big deal because
when that happens and essentially when
the New Mutants finally catch up with
death bird immediately Sunspot is in
love he's just kind of like yeah you
know Robert DeCosta is all about this
girl now one thing to understand about
Robert DeCosta is he was always you know
well not really always I mean in more
recent years it's kind of it's kind of
waxed in right in the more recent
stories with like Avengers and New
Avengers he was kind of like the
hardcore guy when you got into like all
new uh New Mutants more or less you know
when he when he essentially was kind of
leading his own team you know he was
really kind of the Joker and that theme
has kind of remained since but in a lot
of ways he and Sam Guthrie were kind of
the one-two punch of the comedic relief
and just the fun guys right they were
just fun to read about it's one of the
things that made them so popular over
the years but like he's immediately
smitten for this girl right death bird
is of course the woman that tried to
like usurp the Throne of the Shia Empire
multiple times so she's kind of a dick
but uh but nonetheless as soon as they
arrive the death Commandos immediately
begin their process of saying like Okay
let's start sieging on these guys right
let's let's basically take their ship
out and let's try to eliminate them now
as they Stow aboard the ship what they
end up finding out is they bit off more
than they can chew now here's the
important thing to understand in the
shiar Empire you have the Imperial Guard
and then you have the death Commandos
because the death Commandos are
considered to be cannon fodder and
because they can't nobody can really
acknowledge that they exist they're not
composed of the most powerful beings out
there right if they were the the
equivalent of the annihilates right you
had like Silver Surfer and you had Beta
Ray Bill and you had draxa destroy and
you had Gladiator if you had a team that
was composed of like this Powerhouse of
individuals well the whole universe
would know about their existence right
so the easiest way to kind of keep them
under the radar is to just basically
compose a team of cannon fodder and
that's essentially it now it doesn't
mean they're useless but what it does
mean is that we couldn't look at them
and expect them to be capable of taking
on any of the X-Men related teams and
that's exactly what happens here right
for the most part once they Stow aboard
this ship the various members of the
team are taken out quite readily by the
New Mutants there's not a whole lot of
struggle going on here right I mean it's
just using their various abilities and
overpowering the team like that if this
was the Imperial Guard this fight would
have been over before it even began
right the New Mutants would have been
absolutely decimated they never would
have stood a chance because the Imperial
Guard is the show a force from the shiar
Empire right like they're it's like
their versions of the Avengers you know
like so as a result of that the death
Commandos end up basically detonating
the ship of the New Mutants presumably
leaving everybody for debt now what this
does is this picks back up with Ed
rissen's uh portion of the New Mutants
and this is where the second part of the
story kind of comes into play right you
have New Mutants on Earth and then
you've got New Mutants in space this
part of the story we're going to kind of
ham through pretty quickly not a whole
lot doing here uh it's basically really
just kind of a retcon in so far as you
had viku is out there he had his wife
and they were kind of living their own
lives and and ultimately ended up
settling up with beak's parents because
of the fact that beach parents are
basically dying and it was kind of
trying to spend those last few moments
together and that's why he never showed
up on gracoa when you ended up having
like the kind of consolidation of the
mutant population now what you also had
was Manon and his sister who had the
ability to manipulate the emotional
state of other people and so kind of
initiating a bit of a fight going on
here uh he ended up having like kind of
the leader of the of the gang the guy
was kind of like hey like we're looking
for medicines from cocoa you're gonna go
there you're going to get them for us
you're gonna bring them back this guy
really kind of brings them to Sharp
relief the idea that he's really kind of
working for a cartel and specifically
for the government really kind of seems
to be the case so the government's
trying to find ways to attain the
various medicines of kakawa because of
their abilities to enhance the lives of
other people now this is really designed
to kind of hit at the notion that like
it's not really just some governments
and organizations out there that are
like keeping mutants contained and not
allowing mutants to leave using them as
like a labor force different things like
that but there are governments out there
who are going by you know to extreme
lengths even so far as like kidnapping
mutants in order to ran some medicines
out of cocoa for the survival of those
mutants for their lives and it kind of
makes sense because Krakow is so
protective of their mutant population
and wouldn't really open wouldn't risk
open Warfare with governments right you
know it'd be easy for the X-Men to just
send in a strike game and then just like
annihilate you know all those soldiers
and then take the X-Men back but it
would be considered an act of War on on
humanity and so of course that would
lead into a full-scale war between the
mutant population and humans and as
we've seen over the years in Marvel
Comics that war only ever really goes in
one of two extremes either it leads to
the total Destruction of the X-Men
Twitter and really the mutant population
which is what Jonathan Hickman was
really hitting at with the house and
powers of X stories or if we if you guys
remember that story where you had uh
Magneto who basically destroyed you know
all life on Earth it leads to the to the
mutant population annihilating all of
humanity right so it can kind of go
either way here but the long and short
of this is that ultimately in the kind
of huge breakout of firefighting and so
on and so forth and and you know this
earth-based team of New Mutants trying
to rescue Beek and his wife and their
kids and so on and so forth that beak is
injured and beak's parents are both
killed and so in response to that this
leader of this you know kind of field
team or less this main bad guy uh you
know ends up basically saying like then
he's more or less a failure here right
his task was to gather you know
medicines from cocoa by ransoming off
the uh the the members of the New
Mutants but because of the fact that
he's failed the cartel would kill him
and then of course it would reflect
poorly on the government and so on and
so his statement is more people will
come after you right like more folks are
going to come after you and the guy
basically awesome self right it's a
super quick end to the end of the whole
thing but the the big retcon here kind
of comes into play when you end up
having Maxine and Manon who basically
use their powers to to essentially wipe
the mind of beak his wife and their kids
of beak's parents having died the way
they did instead they're replaced with
memories of beach parents having died
some time ago of old age and that's
essentially it the big takeaway here and
it only really matters if you're a fan
of the character of and his wife is that
essentially you can kind of go forward
now in Marvel Comics with the whole
history that he had there of like his
parents and so on and so forth all being
removed right so it's basically beaked
the way he was at the beginning of his
introduction in Marvel Comics it's not
really important unless you're a fan of
that character it may come back to roost
and Ed Briston is really kind of leaving
some some threads for future plot lines
to come into play here but again we can
kind of pass through that pretty quickly
and the reason why is because the the
biggest kind of brunt of what's going on
here is really with with what's
happening with this new Mutant team in
space now again what we're gonna see
when we get into the X-Men Comics is
that once you know everything kind of
gets sorted out that they're really
gonna seem to kind of blend in that
everything is going to sort of go back
to the to the status quo of them being
there and the new Mutant comic looks
like it will actually focus on what Ed
brison is doing here but again we'll
cross that bridge once we get to it but
the long and short is that with the the
various New Mutants being taken captive
by the uh by the death Commandos and
more or less kind of being tortured
being knocked out that kind of a thing
that the days ultimately saved by
DeCosta and really by by desperate when
she takes out a couple of these guys uh
you know black cloak and so on now this
is important and the reason why this is
important is really the way that that
Jonathan Hickman does it for a lot of
people out there who are new when it
comes to the X-Men they don't really
know much about the shiar they don't
really know much about death bird or the
landra or Gladiator or any of that stuff
and it's really kind of foreign to them
and over the years deathbird had kind of
been depicted as this sort of political
Saboteur in the sense that she was
always vying for the throne and would
take it by any means that she could but
the reality is that deathbird is a
prodigious fighter she is exceedingly
good in hand-to-hand combat not the
absolute best in Marvel Comics right
she's no task master but she is really
really good in being able to hold her
own against other people having a kind
of ruthlessness having a murderous
streak really sort of amplifies that and
makes her more exemplary in her ability
to fight we don't know Holds Barred and
so because of that she's able to take
these guys out pretty quickly and
essentially rescue the rest of the New
Mutants and then you kind of get this
moment where you know where she kind of
kisses Robert DeCosta so it really kind
of seems to be of a BL of a bit of a
blooming romance there the important
thing to understand is deathbread will
do whatever she needs to do in order to
achieve her goal even if it means
leading Robert DeCosta on right and he's
buying into it like full on
and so what this does is it basically
leads to to this kind of conversation
I'm not really a huge conversation of
sorts but the arrival of the New Mutants
really into into Shear space right
finally showing up on the doorstep of uh
of of gladiator and the Shia Empire and
when that happens of course death bird
arriving here uh you know one of the one
of the things she does is you know kind
of talking to the daughter of the landra
is she says like my my task being
brought here is to basically be your
tutor to be your instructor now there's
a couple reasons why this is being done
it's being done one because what it does
is it gives Jonathan Hickman the ability
to show us who who death bird is right
to kind of give us an indication of her
character what she's about to sort of
show us and kind of give new readers the
rose on what kind of a person she is the
other part of this is it's better to
have the devil on the on your right hand
than to be in their path and that's true
here right with death bird she's always
looking to take the throne and so it's
better to have her in a position to
where you can kind of keep an eye on her
than to just have her out there in space
somewhere and not really knowing what it
is that she's planning but there's also
kind of an honor bound thing here right
really as her niece death Bird's kind of
Honor Bound not in real any kind of
agreement that was struck but just
because of the fact that the new ruler
is again basically blood now deathbird
will probably try to take the throne
that's probably going to try to happen
it's just the nature of her character
but what she says is my job as as your
instructor here is to basically teach
you what it means to be a warrior is to
teach you the history and the nature of
of the shiar Empire and your first
lesson is that there's no mercy for
traitors and she immediately basically
throws a spear at Oracle with the
intention to kill her and of course
Gladiator catches it in turn but what it
does is it leads to an all-out fight
between the two right now this is kind
of interesting here and it's almost kind
of like a mini Phoenix Saga story right
in the sense that in the original
Phoenix Saga in order to determine
whether or not Jean Gray as the Phoenix
would live or die the X-Men had to fight
the Imperial Guard and they lost right
it was just kind of a display of how
powerful the Imperial Guard was but it's
kind of this this quick little moment
here the reality is that as you see this
unfold for the most part the New Mutants
are kind of able to hold their own if
I'm being honest with you guys it
shouldn't really be that way but what
you are talking about are some different
kinds of Powers right it'd be different
if the New Mutants had the exact same
Powers as the original X-Men and then
like they were able to hold their own it
wouldn't really make a whole lot of
sense here but you've got Sunspot who's
able to channel solar energy in a way
that the other X-Men weren't really able
to do you've got Sam Guthrie who can
basically just kind of you know fly at
people more or less but you've got some
you got a different kind of display of
powers here wolfbane shouldn't really be
here I mean it's you know wolf Spain's
okay rain Sinclair's okay she's just
like a really ferocious fighter that can
make herself into a wolf that's
basically it magic is really the one
that kind of has the ability to turn the
tide she's very very overpowered but
before we really get too far into this
uh the daughter of Alondra basically
tells everybody to stop and says explain
what's going on here and the response of
gladiator is really kind of the response
that it always is really kind of
solidifying his role that gladiator as
the leader of the Imperial Guard serves
the Throne of the Shia Empire it doesn't
matter who's on that Throne his job is
to protect the shiara Empire and to
protect the throne and in this instance
from his perspective a deathbird is back
to her old tricks again right trying to
sub you know take out members of the
Shia and secure a place in the throne
and so on and so forth what does bird
ends up revealing here is that Oracle
tried to have death bird kill that
Oracle was actively working against the
wishes of what was best for the Shia
Empire now the reality is that where
princess Sandra is kind of here as the
new ruler of the throne and deathward
was being brought here in order to serve
as a kind of Aid to Zandra what this
means is that that Oracle was working
against the empress and doing that is an
act of heresy right it's an act of
treason of the highest order punishable
by death and so when when Gladiator asks
is this true the response of Oracle is
yes that is absolutely meant to be true
that gladiator as far as Oracle is
concerned is the one who is Meant To
Rule and there's a kind of validity
there and in terms of her argument the
reason why is because Gladiator is a
warrior right that's what he is he's not
a politician he doesn't care about
politics he's a warrior he'll do
politics because he had to when he was
the magistrix when he was the Magister
when he was the leader of the Shia
Empire but it wasn't really his bread
and butter he undertook the throne
because somebody needed to and as an
honorable man Oracle found a kind of
solace in that right something that
hadn't really been found for quite some
time that with Alondra she did kind of
have a strong streak but the reality was
she couldn't really maintain her own
position right she relied on other
people around her to maintain her
position as the empress which is
technically kind of the role right
that's why you have the Imperial Guard
that's why you have a royal bodyguard
that's why you have people like Oracle
and so on and so forth but with
gladiator if somebody came running upon
him wanting to challenge the throne he
could hold his own in that fight right
as a throntian his powers change based
on his uh based on his confidence and if
his confidence is booming he is an
absolute demon right it's just
ridiculous how powerful he is and so as
a result of that uh really it's kind of
one of these things where at the end of
the day uh Gladiator says you know I
appreciate your candor but you worked
against the throne the punishment for
this is death and that's basically where
Xander steps in the daughter of the
laundry and says no we're not going to
do that instead you are going to serve
as as basically my advisor right you're
going to serve as my right hand that's
going to be your punishment and the
reason why this is kind of a punishment
here is because it's considered to be
dishonorable because now Oracle
basically owes a life debt to to
princess Sandra meaning if she betrays
that then she will die and there'll be
no version she won't be exiled or
anything like that she'll be eliminated
right so to kind of be humiliated and
embarrassed and then made to serve as an
advisor as opposed to a member of her
royal guard is a huge downgrade right so
things are kind of a struggle there and
so what this does is of course it leads
to the to the New Mutants arriving back
on Earth with a day more or less having
been saved but the the biggest takeaway
from all this and this is really kind of
the reasons why Jonathan Hickman seems
to have crafted this story is one Sam
Guthrie chooses to stay behind right so
basically the whole mission was for
nothing
the whole mission was for not but then
you end up learning that Robert DeCosta
actually bought one of the apartment
complexes on the Shia Homeworld in order
to be closer to death bird because again
he's kind of smitten with her and so him
and Sam Guthrie are going to kind of be
hanging out so basically sunspots gonna
be staying behind it looks like staying
on on uh on chandelark but the other big
thing that kind of comes out of this is
Cyclops begins having a conversation
with gladiator now keep in mind while
they don't really relate all that often
they're well aware of who the other is
and that was one of the big things that
came out of Chris claremont's Phoenix
Saga is that where the X-Men did lose to
the Imperial Guard the Imperial
developed a huge amount of respect for
the X-Men because of what they were
fighting for because of the of the
strength and vigor they were fighting
with and because of what they believed
because of their efforts on Earth
there's a kind of Honor there's a kind
of respect that comes with that right
like kind of respect among Warriors it's
really what this is this is one of the
reasons why during John I'm sorry during
a Chris claremont's X-Men uh Cyclops
became so prominent right became such a
huge character is because he was just
kind of like the boy scout more or less
understand Lee and Jack Kirby it wasn't
until you got to Claremont that it was
like dude there's some meat and potatoes
to this guy right like there's some
there's some cool build up here that
that's what kind of led into the house
of M era and uh and really kind of like
the fall of Cyclops and why it was so
intriguing and so cool is because you
were following this you know 60-year
story of this character watching him
grow and expand and kind of change over
the years and different things like that
it was exceedingly well done but what's
Cyclops requests of uh of gladiator is
to basically have one of the uh one of
the krakowan gates installed on Chandler
that's a big thing because what it does
is it grants the X-Men instant access to
the shiara Empire they can walk through
a gate on krakowa and come through a
gate there now this is also a huge
moment because what it does is it
basically solidifies the notion that the
gates of krakowa are Universe wide you
can reach any point in the universe with
a krakowan gate now how far it takes you
to get to a location to install a gate
there is relative to how fast you can
travel from one location to the next
right so you know using the technology
of Reed Richards and then traveling to
this location it would work for the most
part but with regards to this this
instance here this is kind of a big deal
right because what you sort of get is
Robert DeCosta and Sam Guthrie sort of
back together as their one-two punch
comedic Duo which is going to be awesome
the X-Men now have a gate in on on the
Shia Homeworld meaning they can reach
them at any point in time and the Shia
can come to Earth at any point in time
it sets things up for some big
crossovers between these characters
right between these teams which is a
pretty big deal because having the the
Imperial Guard and the X-Men working
together is no small thing that's
actually really really awesome
okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and we are picking back up with uh
Jonathan Hickman's X-Men now here's the
thing this is kind of funny you guys
recall when we were covering New Mutants
and we had that situation where the uh
star Jammers had just kind of stolen
this artifact right like at the very
beginning of the new Mutant Story the
star Jammers stole this artifact and
left the New Mutants behind in order to
be captured this is one of those things
that Jonathan Hickman does where he
takes a small little thing and he ties
it into a big thing later on down the
line now what's even more interesting is
this will become even more important
later on down the line especially
because we're probably going to end up
having like some pretty massive or
significant conflict or something like
that keep in mind that it might take
about three years for this whole thing
to flesh out that's about how long it
took for his Avengers and New Avengers
to conclude right A lot of people forget
that a lot of people think the whole
thing was written in like a year doesn't
really work that way it took quite some
time to reach the Finish Line when it
came to that story but what we're
basically shown here is what's called
The Brute and there's a you know the
brood race itself it's kind of on the
the fringes of Shia's space or at least
one facet of it is but essentially these
brood have come to the realization that
this artifact that was initially taken
by the star Jammers and that's arrived
with the New Mutants on Earth is
basically a king egg now what this means
and why it matters will become important
as we get through this story but and of
course we'll do a full-on explanation
about The Brood you know here in a
little bit because they really are the
universe's most dangerous race right
like they they're it's it's crazy how
dangerous they are what we end up doing
here is basically waking up with Vulcan
now one of the things to keep in mind
here is that initially when Gabriel
Summers first showed up uh really seemed
to First return during the events of
dawn of X we didn't really know why he
was here right we didn't even really
know why he wasn't the same villain that
he was you know after the events of
deadly Genesis right if you guys recall
the video that we did on X-Men deadly
Genesis it basically detailed the return
of Vulcan Vulcan essentially being a
villain of sorts uh kind of Hell been on
on a mission of Revenge and then
ultimately after learning the truth you
know he ended up traveling to the Shia
Empire conquered it and then went to war
with the Inhumans and the cree and so
because of that you know he's a pretty
significant threat like he's an Omega
Level mutant he's wildly powerful but
during the events of Donna of X he was
suddenly there right he was presumed or
basically seemed to have died you know
earlier in in Marvel Comics and then he
was back and seemingly totally different
with no real recollection of who he was
what we know now by virtue of what
Hickman's been showing us is that he was
resurrected but he was resurrected
without the memories of what he had done
presumably during the events of Rise and
Fall the Shia Empire and all that kind
of stuff um it kind of sucks because
that was some really cool storytelling
when it came to Vulcan but at the same
time it also kind of made sense right
because he was a character that Marvel
just never really knew what to do with
right so it kind of gets Hickman the
ability to basically rework him and make
him his own thing the reason why I gave
you that bit of an explanation is
because what vulcan's been doing is
having dreams right having dreams and
nightmares the same dream every single
night and as always the same dream that
he has where basically he seems to like
conquer uh the entirety of the Shia
Empire and then basically the point
where he dies right that kind of seems
to be the same negative dream he has all
the time the issue with this is that
before he can really detail things any
further suddenly the brooder making
their way to Earth and that's when
everybody begins to panic that's when
all hell begins to break loose because
the The Brood are not one of these races
where they just kind of show up and they
say like we are The Brood we're here for
a thing and we demand that you give us
that thing and if you don't then there's
going to be trouble boy I I promise you
there's gonna be trouble it doesn't
really work that way right they just
show up and they're like give us your sh
like that's basically what they are
they just they just like they just Debo
people is really all it is right and so
as a result of that the Broods showing
up here they just crash land on Earth
that's one of the reasons why I kind of
wanted to hold off on this bit of an
explanation because the brood are no
joke right The Brood originally appeared
in Marvel Comics back in uh Uncanny
X-Men number 155 right and right off the
bat they were just like this race is
Savage like in the most extreme degree
they were so Savage and things had gone
South for the X-Men so bad that actually
Xavier believed they had died and that's
why he formed the New Mutants team the
crazy thing here is that this is a race
that literally just relies on
overwhelming numbers that's what they
are they're like the Xenomorphs from the
alien franchise right just overwhelming
number and that's kind of what goes on
here is that the brooder here looking
for something and you can't reason with
them you can't bargain with them all you
can do is just fight them off and so the
X-Men really kind of have to figure out
why their brood are here and then you
know kind of nip that problem in the
butt and they don't really know right
they don't really know why the brooder
here all they really know is that The
Brood are attacking now the answer comes
in the form of a younger member of The
Brood called Brew basically brewed
without the Deep now he was a character
that originally appeared back in uh
astonishing X-Men vol 3 issue number 40.
who was basically a member of The Brood
who was being grown in a lab that was
ran by sort the sentient World
observation and response Department in
order to understand the brood physiology
now they also had a brood Queen when The
Brood Queen was freed she left Brew
behind because unlike the normal members
of the brewed drones uh Brew felt like
compassion and love and things like that
and so he was basically ostracized kind
of outed from the community and then
sort of Left Behind now eventually he
was taken in by the X-Men and he had
essentially been a member of the team
ever since he he has intimate knowledge
on like The Brood race and its form and
its function and different things like
that and he's the one that basically
tells the X-Men their brood are here
because of this King Egg and this is
this is like they will not stop and he's
right like Brew is right that's the
important thing to understand the X-Men
may stop this wave of the brute the
problem with that is the next wave will
come and then after that is the next
wave and after that is the next wave and
the and I mean you got to remember this
is a race that spans in in like
countless numbers the trillions right
spread all over the entirety of the
universe right they're everywhere like
they're all over the place just because
you don't see them doesn't mean they're
not there they're like termites right
like they could be all over the place in
your wall but until you see one you
never know they're actually there or
unless your walls start falling apart
right like you go to you go to tap part
of your wall and the whole thing
collapses well then then you know you
got termites but up and you know aside
from something like that this is a race
that will constantly show up it is a
battle of attrition and they'll just
wear the X-Men down until they get what
they want and then they will leak and so
Cyclops makes the smart move and cyclops
is like let's bail out of here right so
he ends up grabbing Vulcan he ends up
grabbing basically everybody he can he
grabs Havoc he's like let's get out of
here and they end up bolting and
basically you know jumping through one
of the gates heading for sure space
right one of the Cohen Gates Again we
talked about how Cyclops made that
request at the end of The Last Story
that we did on new music this is the
reason why those little tidbits matter
because it all kind of comes together
when it comes to Hickman storytelling
and so what you end up getting here is
is basically a member of the accuser
core now why this accuser core is here
the accusers of course being agents of
the creek why this accuser is here will
become important as time goes on but
this accuser is basically trying to get
information out of Robert DeCosta and
out of Sam Guthrie in order to find out
where this King Egg artifact is now of
course this is you know Robert de casa
kind of goofing around and being a
little silly and so on and so forth but
the fact that this is is being done by
DeCosta at least by this accuser does
not go unnoticed by the super guardian
and so because that she basically ends
up chiming into the to the Shia Empire
specifically to the magistrix you know
to the gladiator's agent and basically
says hey look there's an accuser on the
edge of CR space we gotta respond that
leads to the Shia and you know she are
getting involved right because they
don't take too kindly to a member of
their rate you'll do a member of the
accuser Corps showing up on the doorstep
of their of their empire right it's like
not really your worst enemy but
certainly like a Potential Threat
showing up on your doorstep and then
just kind of you know loitering around
your property right like I mean if
you're if you're like I am in Kentucky
we'll just get out and shoot you right I
mean that's just kind of how it is
that's how it is in Kentucky right you
go loitering around the wrong property
they'll just come out and shoot you like
it's it's kind of nuts in the the City
of Lexington and in Louisville they
don't do that because you can't Fire
Within the city limits but nonetheless
you know at this point we kind of end up
jumping to the past and this is where we
sort of get this big explanation on
everything that's going on here right
like everything with the King Egg and
all that kind of stuff this is why these
things are so important is because it's
Hickman kind of changing a lot of things
right what we're basically told here is
that 8 000 years ago the cree ended up
stumbling across the route and how The
Brood Pro created was by literally
infecting another biological being right
and basically rematerializing them into
the brood and so what they ended up
learning is that you know the breed
themselves consume not just the host but
all the hosts knowledge right so in a
lot of ways you're like a biological
version of the Borg from Star Trek you
know where the bork basically assimilate
you and all your knowledge gets you know
assimilated into the hive into the the
board Collective and so they know
everything you know hence the reason why
the Borg were able to decimate the
Federation during the Battle of wolf 359
because they knew everything for card
new they how to circumvent the uh the
federation's defense systems and all
that kind of stuff and so with that
being the case there's a kind of idea
here that comes along where the cree
basically come up with this idea to
weaponize The Brood now this is an
important thing to understand is that
you got into these various stories and
different aspects of The Brood were kind
of expanded on over the years right in
the sense that you had basically what
was called the great mother uh which
which essentially the hierarchy followed
that you had an empress who was like the
absolute Divine ruler you know the
absolute ruler of all the brood and then
while most brewed that existed within
the universe existed by virtue of
another biological being being turned
into a brood the empress also had what
were called her firstborn right her
actual biological children like you know
giving birth to actual brood after the
empress who had the firstborn and then
you had the Queens then you had like
smaller versions of queens and then you
had drones right so but the the issue
here is that at the time we never really
knew what the origin of The Brood was we
just knew that they were there in Marvel
Comics we just knew that they kind of
existed there was no real explanation in
terms of where they came from or
anything like that what Jonathan Hickman
basically changed up here is as he
introduced the idea of they're basically
being a kind of Rift in space well The
Brood are not native to the main Marvel
Universe right they're not from here
instead they're from a collapsed
Universe like a collapsing universe that
basically fell apart and ended up coming
here and so essentially they're they're
not from this universe they're from a
different universe but now they inhabit
inside this universe right and so that's
where things get a little murky that's
where things get a little chaotic is
because they're not really from here but
the cree look at them nonetheless and
say okay so the entire Form and Function
of this brood race is they essentially
follow a hive mentality that you have a
singular leader under you know that
controls the entire Hive and then within
that Hive you have various you know
queens and you know each one of the
Queens leads a faction different things
like that you have all these these
little situations set up but what we can
do is we can weaponize all of this we
can basically create a singular being
that can dominate the entirety of the
brute Hive and then basically either
seed or or so disarray or we can use it
to our own ends whatever the case is we
can weaponize this whole thing and that
was the basis by behind the creation of
the King Egg specifically because of the
fact that the Supreme intelligence had
looked into the future at least used a
mathematical probability to determine
which of the existing races across the
cosmos and Marvel Comics would be the
most viable threat to the to the cree
later on down the line and determined
that it would be the shiar and that's
true right the shiar are technically the
most advanced race in Marvel Comics
they're composed of a bunch of different
races all of which have sworn a fatality
to the shiar Empire or maybe they were
just straight up conquered but whatever
the case is like they're composed of a
bunch of different races that all have
their benefits and drawbacks right
strontians and different things like
that who are all essentially analogs for
Superman and so as a result of this it's
one of these things where like all hell
can pop off here you know all hell can
break loose and so kind of jumping to
Gladiator and the accuser this guy's
dealt with pretty readily right you know
this one you'll kind of show me back to
the to the present day glad you're going
after this guy deals with this accuser
pretty quickly right ends up knocking
him out of the ship the accuser dies in
space and then he's eaten by one of the
giant you know space whales basically
The Brood are controlling to travel from
one location to the next what The Brood
do they basically you know kill these
things and then hijack the nervous
system and then take it over right and
then just kind of pilot it it's like
controlling a human as a puppet it's
more or less what what this is
equivalent to the issue is that with the
initial expectation of the star Jammers
and uh you know the the Shia Imperial
Guard and like the X-Men and all these
groups here is like okay you know let's
go ahead and like land on this space
station and then you know leave you know
send The Brood egg to the to the surface
and then I guess the king actually the
surface and call it a day this station
is destroyed as well leaving them no
real option except to you know basically
crash land on this on this sentient
world and that's where things kind of
pop off is it because over the years you
know what what Hickman really hits at
here is Across the Universe what you
have is you have like all these varying
factions of of the brute right you have
like a faction here and you have a
faction there and you have a faction
back there and you got a faction over
there and they're all led by individual
Queens right each one of the Queens
leads those factions there's no
indication here that there is currently
an empress in existence and so what this
means is that all the brood individual
factions are self-governing there's no
one controlling all of them so factions
will go to war or with other factions
over territory or resources or whatever
the case happens to be and so as a
result of that because of this King Egg
what this is doing is basically it's
like The Dinner Bell right it's it's
bringing in all these brood from all
across the cosmos right because brood
can can smell this King egg from
galaxies away right so like three or
four galaxies away and if and if one of
those galaxies there's a billion brood
then guess what that billion brood is
heading to this planet that's exactly
what's happening here and so with that
going down like Voodoo constantly
arriving on this world and while you do
have some exceedingly powerful
characters here you've got Vulcan you've
got Cyclops you've got you know you've
got Gladiator you got all these guys
while you have some exceedingly powerful
characters here the reality is no matter
how powerful they are they will start to
fall one by one they will start to fall
and they will start to die and they'll
they'll lose against the power of The
Brood that's just the way it is these
just overwhelming numbers as powerful as
these guys are they cannot continually
fight against billions of drones for any
real continued amount of time and so all
it's going to take is for one of them to
be infected then suddenly it all stops
in the in the middle of nowhere all the
birds stop moving just like that like
they stop moving they stop attacking
they all just back off and they all just
stop and so what you end up having of
course are like these massive you know
brew that are sort of standing around
there and then you've got Brew himself
who basically ate the egg right like he
consumed the egg and that's really the
way this King Egg Works it doesn't
really give birth to a to a brood King
instead it contains a kind of substance
inside of it a kind of syrup and the the
individual that consumes it will kind of
become the new rude King more or less
now presumably because of the fact that
brood basically exists in terms of their
control over you know the the Queens
control the drones and the Queens in
turn are controlled using a combination
of like pheromones and telepathy what
this seems to do is basically amplify
the abilities of an existing brute right
so you know take that brood and then
give them like a super high level of
telepathy and then like a super Advanced
version of the pheromones so they can
essentially Force the other members of
The Brood or convince the other members
of The Brood to do their bidding but
that's basically what this is right now
you've got a you've got a brood King
which means the entirety of The Brood
race the most dangerous race in all of
existence is currently under the control
of a singular being and that's cool
right that's a super cool idea but the
brooder are are super awesome guys I'm
really excited to see what Jonathan
Hickman ends up doing with it
make sure you guys hit the Subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and uh
make sure you guys hit the like button
if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
um we're we're kind of in the midst of
of Swords of X right this great big huge
22 part series and one of the things
that I realize is that we never really
finished up X-Force right so we're going
to kind of run through X-Force really
quick today finish uh finish volume one
and then uh run through volume two and
then kind of continue on with swords of
X and with some of the series like uh
like Wolverine for example Wolverine
picks up with swords of Activision
number six so when we get around to that
point we're just gonna cover the first
six issues kind of call it a day the
whole idea here with this with with this
X-Force comic is in the first couple
issues we had this scenario where Xavier
was killed if you guys remember that
right Xavier was taken out and it was
just by some individuals who managed to
infiltrate krakowa right so we're kind
of going a little far back right we're
going towards really the the end of last
year uh in the beginning of this year
right so we're a little behind on this
I'd say we're probably about 10 months
behind on this the idea here is that
with these guys having breached the
notion behind this is that first they're
trying to figure out who these guys
belong to and then two how they managed
to get in right it's kind of the
continuing talking point that's going on
in this little bit of a story but what
they end up doing is is kind of
teleporting to a particular location at
least traveling there by way of one of
the Cocoon Gates and then using a kind
of mind sketch to a degree right which
basically takes Sage with them Sage of
course having what's essentially a
computer for a brain but it allows Jean
Gray to use her telepathy to kind of
analyze the the digital imprint that was
left there and to kind of figure out
kind of retrace these steps to these
guys right to kind of follow them from
the point when they arrived on cocoa and
sort of fought like Trace their steps
back right Trace them back to an
eventual location now this ultimately
leads to the quiet Council itself
meeting and then kind of discussing and
asking like what do we do here that when
it comes to to this strike that was
launched on the X-Men that what it
looked like is it was designed for the
purpose of accessing their computer
systems and basically acquiring or
taking their wealth right that seemed to
be the goal that was going on it seemed
to more or less be a heist and that's
kind of the question is why would they
launch that attack right like why launch
a heist against krakowa if they're
looking for information or they're
looking for resources whatever the case
happens to be now you had a lot of
pharmaceutical companies and a lot of
companies that were basically you know
kind of you know owning governments
essentially that didn't really want to
innovate but with X-Men popping up and
the mutant population creating
Pharmaceuticals that were out basically
outshining anything that the rest of the
pharmaceutical companies in the world
could produce then in turn it was like
okay well let's try to sabotage them or
steal their technology right and that's
kind of where they are at the moment
it's kind of like okay these guys are
implementing a heist these guys are
trying to take what we have what do we
do here now Xavier takes more of an
approach and saying that this is
something very similar to like the 12
labors of Hercules right in the sense
that we as the mutant population were
Hercules in his early years meaning he
remained in hiding he didn't he was
afraid that people would try to come
after him or something along those lines
but when he learned his true goal when
he learned his true purpose the son of
Zeus when he learned what he was really
about then in turn he stepped out there
into the world and started undergoing
the 12 laborers and became the Hercules
that we know today and Xavier kind of
takes that sort of scenario and applies
it to themselves and says for years and
years and years mutant kind was hiding
we tried to stay out of the Limelight we
tried to stay away from conflict we try
to move away from those things It
ultimately led to us basically falling
victim right we were still being chased
we were still being hounded we just
believed if we took the peaceful
approach that we could somehow talk them
into believing in a better thing but the
issue that you have here so this is
what's so interesting about Xavier's
philosophy now the fact that you don't
believe that guns are okay doesn't
change the fact that a person's standing
at you or standing in front of you with
a gun pointed to your face right like
they're gonna pull a trigger so what are
you gonna do the days of trying to use
words and talk people into believing
what you believe and to try to get them
to understand those days are gone that
now it's the X-Men and really it's the
mutant population's job to either drag
Humanity into the life or leave Humanity
to its fate and just let it suffer and
conquer the world right like just kind
of take things over say if you can't
leave this world into a better place
then we will and that's when he kind of
says what we need here is a team that
basically is going to serve as the
intelligence arm of the X-Men with that
being the case they in turn say we're
going to reconstitute X-Force and
X-Force is going to basically be our CIA
type team where they're going to be our
intelligence gathering apparatus the
first they do is they go to visit Fort
right and then Forge is upgrade again
you know the guy who makes weapons all
kinds of armor and arms and Armament
technology and and you know suits of
armor things like that and they
basically hit him up and say like we
need your help in developing weapons
what he's been doing here is he's been
taking krakowan biology right so pieces
of cocoa and then basically hybridizing
it which is to say blending it with
weapons technology and what he's kind of
done here is he's actually created a
kind of device that bonds itself to the
hand and he can do any number of things
it can shoot energy right it can it can
turn itself into like knives and
stabbing weapons it's a pretty powerful
piece of technology the other thing that
was going on here is that somehow and we
don't really know how but somehow cocoa
got its hands on adamantium in a liquid
state now the reason why I say this is a
big thing is because it's very difficult
to do the formula for for adamantium
isn't readily available somehow they
managed to get their hands on it but the
idea is that if they ever have to bring
Wolverine back they can Bond adamantium
to his skeleton but this is kind of a
big deal because what it also means is
that if there are other mutants out
there that have the ability to heal
right they have healing factors you
could bond adamantium to them if they're
willing to undergo the process right so
it's it's actually a really awesome
concept but one of the first things they
do is they basically kind of have this
this Mission they go on to a place
called the point or at least it's kind
of a reference for for where Beast is
operating out of but they end up
realizing that this location this this
kind of strike that's taking place uh
you know with regards to this this
heisis going on is a chance for them to
basically track these guys down and find
out why it is they track why they attack
or KOA in the first place right and so
what you have here is basically a place
where you've got human allies right
there and they're eventually called you
know Xavier Scholars so people who study
the the philosophies of Xavier his views
and just kind of see what Merit there is
but they're not enemies of the X-Men
right they're kind of they're just
trying to understand the mutant
population of course with this Heist
showing up and with them having you know
different calling you know bits of
cocoon technology at their disposal you
end up having them basically break into
this place kind of reach thicker Cohen
gate and then shut the gate down just as
X-Force is getting in and it leads to
Domino basically kind of bailing out
right you know her you know not really
experiencing any kind of a shut or
anything like that but with the gate
shutting off the way that it does it
cuts Wolverine in half and it kills
Quentin choir but the whole thing behind
this is that with uh with the gate
basically shut down and no real means to
access this facility outside of getting
into an actual vessel and flying there
right so however long that happens to
take uh you end up having black Tom
Cassidy hit up by Domino and then black
Tom Cassidy of course talks to Gateway
and so it's like we need you to teleport
Domino to a location now the other part
of this and kind of a plot thread that's
beginning here and is going to sort of
pick up later on in the the next story
that we do is that Domino's actually
losing her power over luck that's kind
of the nature of domino is that she can
kind of Bend luck to her favor right so
if Domino is walking along a whole bunch
of slot machines her power will tell her
play that slot machine and you'll win a
million dollars right I mean it won't
say like you'll win a million bucks but
it'll just kind of pull her towards that
slot machine and then she'll play it and
then she'll win like 50 million dollars
in Progressive slots right which nobody
ever does but the other part of this is
that with her arriving there of course
she's also met by the arrival of Forge
right Forge is like look I'm not like
sitting this one out right like I got
all these arms and all this technology
and something like that I want to
destroy stuff man I'm tired of sitting
in the lab
actually the whole stance of the whole
stance of Forge now once they get in
here you're kind of jumping back to this
this facility of course Wolverine being
cut in half immediately still starts
killing people but one of the guys who's
returning their gun on Wolverine kind of
spraying him down and at the moment he
kind of looks to be dead right but that
of course gives gives time for Domino
alongside Ford's to show up here right
now once these two show up Domino uses
her technology which actually proves to
be highly effective uh and then of
course Forge using his suit and just
kind of showing up here you got a few
guys who kind of show up try to try to
launch an attack they're all subdued
pretty quickly Domino is a little harsh
on him but the funny thing about this
from from Beast is he's like look okay
these are the only guys that we have
that can give us information on the
original Heist right they are the only
ones that all kind of work together or
at least know what was going on with
that Heist so uh don't kill them like
you can beat the crap out of them if you
want to brutalize them all you want to
but don't kill them and when it looks
like Domino's going to that's when beat
steps in and says you have to stop the
whole purpose of X-Force is to serve as
an intelligence gathering apparatus we
can't gather intelligence if the people
with that intelligence are dead you have
to save at least one of them
you know the other cool thing that kind
of happens here is Forge actually ends
up grabbing Wolverine's pieces and just
kind of smashing them back together and
it's like not heal yourself right like
now heel back up because we need you out
here and so what you end up getting here
is is once it's all kind of said and
done right once you have uh the mission
more or less proving to be successful
the other guys have basically retreated
they've aborted you have Domino who
walks up on one of the guys with the
intention of looking to kill him right
the whole kind of device he has on her
arm basically creates you know something
that looks like Wolverine's claws it's
not really adamantium but something
similar to it a pretty durable material
and it looks like she's going to kill
him and that's when bees is kind of like
you have to stop here right and it's a
it's a truly fearful thing one of the
other things that we kind of found out
in their various investigations is that
one of the things this kind of secretive
organization had been doing was
basically removing pieces of domino
right that's what was going on with her
in the first two issues and why she
looks so scarred they had been cutting
off pieces of her and then basically
seemingly to attach them to like what
looked like Assassin robots or something
like that right these kind of hybrid
beings but in her mind she looks at this
guy and says this guy's probably not
human he's probably not actually human
he's probably one of those weird looking
hybrid so they cooked up in a lab
somewhere we can kill this guy and it
won't really matter but this guy is like
no I'm definitely human and one of the
laws of kakawa is you can't kill humans
unless your own personal life is in
danger this guy's begging for his life
and so ultimately she basically ends up
sparing this guy and initially you have
Beast who does a bit of interrogation
here kind of asking a few questions and
saying like who are you working for
what's the whole deal the guy starts
sobbing telling the story about like his
dog and how his dogs at home somebody
needs to go check on him that kind of a
thing but the torture methods of of
kirkoa are not inhumane but they are
somewhat brutal right depending on on
how you perceive it right where he kind
of spills this this story to beasts and
says like we just get our orders from
the top right like we did this this
wasn't any kind of a political maneuver
it wasn't a political job it wasn't like
a hit job or anything it was designed to
be a heist the responsive Beast is with
one you guys killed Xavier so how much
of a heist could it possibly be and then
two you attacked a political Nation
that's new to the world in the face of
the world being afraid of it how could
this be anything but political inter
Jean Gray who uses her powers and
basically starts to you know attack this
guy's mind and that's where that kind of
violation began to come in right like
reading this guy's mind in a way where
he can't legitimately fight back but at
the same time he also kind of asked for
it so that's when we end up finding out
that this mysterious guy that we saw at
the end of like the first and second
issues is the guy this thief is
basically working for right that they
get their orders from this guy he
doesn't know their name the whole the
whole purpose was for them to go under
krakowa to steal some stuff to go into
that that you know facility steal some
stuff there and then we're gonna sell it
to these guys right part of it was we're
paying you for this Heist and then
you're gonna bring these different you
know these goods and so on to us but
they don't know the guy's name right all
they know is he has like a peacock
tattoo and that's it they don't know his
name they don't know what his face looks
like or any of that stuff or they simply
just no this guy is there somewhere but
from here we pick up with the final
mission of X-Force in this first part of
the story and we end up joining in
what's basically a place called Terra
Verde and Tara Verde is a nation that's
looking to sign a treaty with uh krakowa
for you know in order to access those
various cocoon seeds that Xavier has at
his disposal but the idea behind Tierra
Verde and this is kind of important here
the idea behind Tierra Verde is that
they were at one point the world leader
in what was called telefloronics and
teleflorana was basically kind of it's
kind of this weird wonky word to
describe the idea of creating a means of
healing people to create what are
essentially Nanobots right so super
microscopic machines that were not
really machines but were plant-based in
origin and these could be used for a
number of healing you know healing
factors and different things like that
to heal injuries and so on the problem
with this is that while they were
leading the world with this kind of
research it was still pretty far off
from being something that could one
include human trials and then two be
Mass marketed and the controlled and and
so on and so forth but the relative
early days of their experiments
relatively recently you suddenly had
Xavier who popped up with krakowan seeds
on krakowa and so basically all this
technology vanished right like any
funding they had just disappeared
overnight but within Tierra Verde itself
you also had a guy named president Como
and this was a guy who basically kind of
stabilized the region stabilized this
country which had been warring for quite
some time and so it was really pushing
towards more of a plant-based Society
but the funny thing about this is that
with this treaty being signed you end up
having of course black Tom Cassidy who
attends with Charles Xavier in order to
keep him protected right since blind Tom
Cassidy can control the Earth and so you
end up having these guys who show up and
start kind of manifesting these tendrils
of sorts and immediately start going
after president Como and with that
happening you have Blacktown Cassidy who
kind of implements his power that seems
to kind of shut these down when you have
the attack going after the president
himself black Tom Cassidy of course
saves Xavier is also able to kind of
kind of Stave off the attack from the uh
the Invaders which largely happens off
panel we don't really see that all we
really get is the the statement of black
Tom Cassidy in the sense that like they
basically ran away right they seem to
get scared and just and sort of flee but
the responsive Beast is if these guys
are going to be brave enough to launch
an attack against the president as well
as Xavier at the same time then why just
run right that doesn't really make a
whole lot of sense and so BEAST's
response is that you really tell Sage go
back and pull up all the information
that you can and all the camera feeds
that you can of this whole thing right
like kokom the president himself has
gone through a whole bunch of different
attempts to remove him from power over
the years but somehow this seems a
little bit different and so what you end
up finding out here is that the attack
itself was not designed to go after
president cocom it was designed to go
after his son which is the smartest move
to make if you're going gonna try to
control the president take his son and
any president anybody who's worth any
worth a damn will do whatever it takes
to keep their kid alive right unless
their kids really just that far of a
lost cause and so ultimately when he
came out and said he's not going to side
in the treaty in the aftermath of this
incident the immediate response of
beasts and all them is okay it's because
they have his son but it's because they
took his son and they're forcing his
hand and so what you end up getting is
basically beast and Jean Gray and them
who show up on the doorstep of President
cocom and don't really have any intent
of harming him instead Gene reads his
mind and says okay tell us everything
you know what we end up finding out is
that these weird looking wonky guys of
these tendrils are basically
telefloronic scientists who were taken
over by their own experiments now the
indication here seems to be that these
experiments are almost kind of like
Venom in nature in the sense that
somewhere along the line they develop
some kind of sentience and then
basically became hostile in and of
themselves they kind of became parasitic
and basically latched themselves to
these guys the other part of this is
that if these beings really are
operating in the realm of
self-preservation then it wouldn't be
that far out of the realm of possibility
to create the argument that with
research drying up that there was no
more attempts by this group to you know
to create these guys more so than that
the research was probably being killed
off and so it was these telephonics
basically being killed off themselves
this is really seemingly more of an act
of self-preservation than anything else
but regardless of how you try to slice
it the response of beasts is we have to
go basically launch this strike against
these guys the other part of this this
is really more heavy-handed by Beast is
to say that in his mind telefloronics
are a massive credible threat to the
mutant population and the reason for
that is if telefloronics are a kind of
organization organism that exists out
there and it bonds itself to people then
it can Bond itself to almost anything
else more so than that if it bonded
itself to these guys and they started
evolving over time then what would
happen if we had a telefloronic who's
powerful enough to reach into the world
and control it then at that point you
have a being that could basically go
after the mutant population by targeting
their own Island meaning humans or
mutants would have to like take to the
skies in order to escape you know the
the servers they could never go back to
the surface world again but it basically
creates a scenario where the median
population could could legitimately
stand on the realm of complete and total
eradication right because at that point
then suddenly this being could start
producing different kinds of pheromones
or producing different kinds of
substances from plants that specifically
Target mutants and then basically make
the entire atmosphere of the earth
poison for the mutant population and it
would kill him that's the kind of thing
that we're talking about here it's
far-fetched but the idea of Beast is
it's not that far-fetched right that's
that's what he that's really his biggest
fear like this kind of of hybrid uh
Fusion between these plants and these
humans so yeah these these human beings
could lead to some kind of future
version of these you know telefloronic
beings they could basically turn the
entire weapon or the entire Earth into a
weapon against the mutant population and
then wipe them out right the entire
population would go extinct and so the
response of Beast is do what you have to
do right we cannot leave behind any
Witnesses and we can't leave these
things behind kill them all and that's
the crazy thing is because the
responsive Beast is they're not really
human right when when Gene asks a
question what about what happened to
kill no human the response of Beast is
they're not really human beings in the
first place not anymore they're like
Omega Sentinels they're more machine
than man right twisted and evil consumed
by the dark side but that's basically
what they are right and so Gene
basically eradicates these things using
her powers and then they basically start
going after and attempting to find the
son of President kokom and once they
locate his son they end up finding out
that he's a telefloronic himself and
that he is one of the one of the
individuals out here who's trying to
bring down the trying to bring down his
father right the whole thing was staged
it was all planned by him he staged his
own kidnapping to force his father's
hand the idea behind this is that it
wasn't really as though it was like an
acquisition of money or power or
anything like that I mean it was to a
degree but the the whole stance of the
president's son is that with Terra Verde
being on the verge of telephone a
telefloronic breakthroughs that if they
had succeeded it would have been it
would have put him at the Forefront of
everything right they would have been
like the the wakanda of the healing
world everybody would have come to them
right from this pharmaceutical
standpoint everybody would have come to
them and it would have taken them from a
small little nation that barely just
achieved stability to being like the
center of the of the pharmaceutical
world the other crazy thing that comes
out of this is that these kind of looks
at the situation and says that had this
technology gotten out there right had
telefloron and Scott and out there that
Humanity would have realized there was
an alternative to krakowa medicine and
that they would no longer recognize
mutant sovereignty if that was the case
then in turn it would have caused
massive problems for the mutant
population and so in an act of
maintaining the meat and population
stance as to where they are in terms of
maintaining their power you end up
having beasts basically wipe this guy's
mind like and not even in the sense of
him just like wiping his memories but in
the sense of him basically kind of
recoding the telefloronic uh substance
in his body to essentially eat his mind
alive and all it does is just kind of
leave him in a feeble state right it
leaves him in in a vegetative state and
it leaves his father there you know it's
like your son's here albeit you know
Beast basically saying like which of
these was the two evils right to kill
this guy's son or to tell him his son
was a traitor which of these were the
two the two right things to do keep in
mind Xavier was behind this as well and
that's kind of the nature of these
things right is what had to be done in
order for the mutant population to
maintain his role in in the world and to
achieve its level of power and so what
you end up finding out here is that this
kind of telephlyonic substance inside
the the body of the president is
actually sentient right that he's wholly
telephlyonic not just in terms of it
impacting his body or anything but just
on the biological level it has merged
with him in its entirety he's not just
wielding it as a weapon right like he is
this and so basically it kind of breaks
down and literally leaves the hospital
room and then reforms itself okay so
from here we jump to the next part of
the story and this is this is one of the
things about Benjamin Percy's X-Force
run Benjamin Percy is a good writer but
the biggest issue with his X-Force Run
is it just kind of feels like it's all
over the place the idea here is that we
kind of jump back a little bit there are
there were a couple things going on with
the idea of domino honestly in order to
keep things simple we can largely skim
over it basically like Domino ended up
enlisting the help of Colossus who had
kind of left left Cocoa in the X-Men for
the Savage land in the aftermath of
everything that was going on you know in
the sense of his attack when he was in
uh Russia I think it was and helping to
liberate people you know the injuries he
the injuries he suffered they ended up
of course finding out that the reason
why Domino's uh portions of her skin
were being removed is that that because
this this kind of secretive organization
that existed out there basically served
the purpose of trying to create more
versions of her for whatever their goals
happen to be ultimately Colossus kind of
jumped in front of like a moving train
which was their base or at least part of
their base of operations where their
research was the train was destroyed all
the the samples on the train were
destroyed and Domino ended up dying and
of course they resurrected her from the
dead and then Colossus went back to
doing his thing and that's basically it
right that's basically all that happened
that little segment by no means is any
of that overly important right and it's
kind of weird but the X-Force team is
kind of sent on another mission by beast
but this was kind of a follow-up to the
events of Terra Verde where basically
this turfleronic that had escaped
president cookham's son you know kind of
going out and manifesting on his own has
basically taken taken over the country
on its own right taking over the country
in its entirety now the fact that Beast
was the one who made that call and did
those things it kind of screwed up that
guy's mind and all that leads him to
kind of running this mission on his own
right so it's him and he's the one
basically talking to uh Clinton choir to
uh to Wolverine and to Domino now this
is kind of a big deal because the entire
nature of X-Force because it is so
clandestine relies heavily on trust that
you trust the guy next to you to keep
your back and you trust that the people
who are giving your orders aren't
sending you into like a city on a
suicide mission and they have trust in
beasts that Beast is not going to get
them killed but beasts is in a lot of
ways trying to cover his own tracks here
that when he kind of sends them in there
that it's like okay I need it I need to
know what's going on but I need to know
everything that's going on inside there
and I need you guys to meet with the
president and the problem with this is
that with president cocom he's dead
right like he was literally taken over
by these plans and kind of bonded to a
wall you know it's a pretty screwed up
way the other thing here is that with
these you know with the the whole
country basically being taken over in
such a rapid amount of time it shows us
one what these telefloronics are capable
of in the sense that Beast was right
with their ability to tap into Earth and
then manipulate it for their own ends
and that two they have no regards in
killing people like this this is
basically a dead a dead country Beast
killed everybody here and bees is kind
of trying to keep things quiet the other
part of this is that it's kind of formed
its own kind of society in a lot of ways
and this is like its own kind of plant
life you have what looks like basically
a kind of leopard or a tiger or whatever
it is they kind of like manifest out of
the ground right and then just kind of
starts going after them sort of walks
into the into the temple where all this
seems to sort of be emanating from which
looks like the base of operations for
these guys the other thing that kind of
goes on here is black Tom Cassidy has
had a kind of existential crisis right
he's trying to be a good guy not been
doing very good at it trying to turn
over a new a new Leaf turn into alcohol
in a lot of ways to kind of get himself
put together Beast ends up kind of
enlisting his Aid and saying like we
need you here and with black Tom being
hung over Beast ends up just basically
taking him and saying like we're gonna
get you sober and we're gonna get you
out there into the field this is your
lucky day you want to be a hero go out
there with X-Force and go be a hero
right like go fight the good fight the
other thing that goes on here is you
have Quentin choir who tries to chime
into bees and telling them like this
whole nation is a living organism now
and has killed everybody here and is
taking us out and it grabs Quentin choir
and then snatches him off now once
Clinton choir is pulled in uh you end up
having Wolverine and you have Domino who
basically follow him in there and of
course Clinton choir just kind of
responds to them with like telekinetic
weapons and different things like that
but he's got like a bandana around his
head right so he looks kind of cool but
once they're in here there's a couple
things that go down one is that this
plant life looks like it's been growing
for eons right like it's been growing
for centuries that's kind of the
statement that's given uh it's Wolverine
who kind of gives it so what it looks
like is that these things have been
growing for quite some time this kind of
landscape's been here for a while
there's some sort of of kind of toying
with the idea that this is how the
telefloronix were basically engineered
by using organic like living plant life
that existed out there in that Temple uh
and then kind of bringing it to the
world and then trying to engineer it so
basically like they tapped into what
were basically like evil plants for lack
of a better word and now they're pissed
that kind of seems to be the case the
other part of this and something that I
would say is probably the most knowledge
or probably the most reasonable is that
the plants really have existed here for
quite some time and in fact Benjamin
Percy basically tells us as much but
there was a kind of balance of nature
that existed here right that you had the
the plant life that was there and
presumably over time it would feed on
people but it was a kind of a kind of
balance in this this sort of ecosystem
but that with Beast basically tapping
into this well really not even just
beast beast and the attempts to utilize
telephonics you know for their own
purpose that they created a kind of
imbalance that with Beats cracking the
code of the telephotronics and then
trying to find a way to engineer it for
his own in literally playing Dr
Frankenstein with this kind of plant
life he didn't know anything about but
he shifted the balance of power and that
what has done is has made the plant life
more like really kind of elevated it
right so it's kind of Taken on the form
and become more human-like and elevated
it above its posts right so basically
it's kind of achieved a new level of
power and so that means that that's how
it was able to kind of take over the
entirety of the nation and then answers
the question why it never did that
before presumably because it never
occurred to this plant life or this
plant life wasn't previously capable of
that but whatever the case is beasts
literally altered it in such a way to
where he changed its genetic structure
and made it something holy evil well
we're not really evil but something just
wholly twisted and kind of moved it up
along the food chain and so with that
being the case you have Wolverine and
you have Quentin choir who are both
snatched up right they're both basically
taken away and what these telephotonics
are doing is basically consuming humans
right consuming organic matter and then
like literally eating it for you know
and kind of forming their own Society in
that way it's kind of interesting here
because Wolverine's one of the ones they
take they already took Clinton choir
they already kind of sacrificed and
consumed him right so he's kind of being
converted basically into plant life and
Wolverine's kind of undergoing that
conversion process the the real kicker
here is whether or not Wolverine's
healing Factor can overcome that and it
kind of seems like to a degree it can
but it's not something that works
against his healing Factor right it's
not considered to be a kind of invasive
you know pathogen that is healing Factor
would immediately attack right it's not
like a cold or a flu or something along
those lines what it does is it modifies
their body on the genetic level and for
the most part that kind of seems to sort
of operate under the purview of his
healing factor and his healing Factor
just doesn't really seem to notice it
right and so here either that or his
healing Factor doesn't know what to do
with it so it does nothing but whatever
the case is it basically points to the
idea that Wolverine is susceptible to
this and could be taken over just like
everybody else now the other thing that
goes on here is Jean Gray realizes what
was happening that with Beast basically
leaving her in sage in the dark not
really even telling this mission was
going on in the first place but Gina
basically probably his mind and realized
what was happening and that's when she
shows up here she's like you basically
lied to everybody you engineer this
whole circumstance one just to see what
could happen too you're trying to find a
way to bring this place into krakowa to
use it for our own ends like you're
making the argument the ends justify the
means but the reality Beast is that you
killed a whole country you killed an
entire nation of people so yeah like
sure what they were doing would have put
cocoa at risk in terms of our place and
the political and social hierarchy of
the world right it would have possibly
slid us down the pole in terms of our
ability to maintain our dominant place
you know with the various medicines and
stuff that we have but you sacrifice a
whole nation of people to do it and and
we as people like we as mutants have to
be better than that we cannot adopt this
philosophy that the ends justify the
means but the reality is that it does
right the ends really do justify the
means because the stance of genes seems
to be taking here is that if Beast had
done nothing and kind of allowed things
to unfold then mutants then everything
the mutant population had worked for
would have failed and her desire to do
the right thing she would have killed
their success right and at the end of
the day that cannot be allowed to happen
right that cannot be allowed to take
place that mutants have struggled long
enough that because of her carrying and
her cold hearted nature she'd killed
everything they worked for and at the
end of the day Beast is like no like
we're not we're not playing that game
right we're not doing that right I did
what I did I make no apologies for it
and yes I sacrificed a whole nation of
people but what's this nation of you
know 100 000 people in comparison to the
millions of mutants that will be here
over time right through just procreation
and so on and the mutants who are here
right now right basically the argument
Beast makes is our need is greater than
theirs and the experiment is worth the
loss right and it's a legitimate
statement and it's an accurate statement
to make right it is it really is worth
the loss and so because of that of
course again Clinton choir he's dead
Wolverine kind of ends up popping up and
manages to make some measure of an
attack but even then he starts to to be
overcome by these Vines again and that's
when you end up having Jean Gray kind of
working together alongside Sage with
sage kind of analyzing this taking the
information of Beast and realizing how
all this is how their how their entire
genetic structure for lack of a better
word how that works the responsive Gene
is we can combine our powers right we
can basically use the power of sage like
her mind and we can use the the power of
Gene herself to kind of anchor everybody
together and the power of black Tom
Cassidy to essentially introduce a kind
of virus into their genetic code
effectively they give the plant life
cancer and break it down and kill the
plant life at a rapid State that's all
it is right just mutated cells right you
know free radicals right but in response
to all that with everything that's
happened and this whole conflict and
you're ending pretty fast Jean Gray
quits right because her whole stance is
X-Force is supposed to exist on a basis
of trust but Wolverine kind of calls her
on it right and says like you were never
really meant for this right like the
nature of X-Force isn't to be this kind
of altruistic group that does good
things because it's the right thing to
do the whole purpose of X-Force is to be
as bad as the bad guys right because
that's how you win you win by becoming
as bad as they are that's just what you
have to do in order to win now there's
no arguing that point Gene is too kind
for that and so she can't be with
X-Force because she can't really do what
needs to be done the other thing that
kind of goes on here is she's sharing a
bath with Wolverine
it's good to see that uh the whole the
whole kind of love triangle between Jean
Gray and cyclops and Wolverine is still
there right that's the Cornerstone of
their character but the the whole thing
about this is it kind of switches over
to a degree in that in the aftermath of
all this that you kind of have autopsies
that are done on the various bodies that
were taken and what you end up finding
out here is that what these
telefloronics have done was actually
managed to achieve the exact same
process as krakowen technology in the
sense that when you have Dr Reyes who
goes to cut one of them open and perform
a kind of autopsy this smaller body
jumps out cuts her throat and takes off
the what telephotronics have managed to
do is find a way to resurrect themselves
that's basically what they what they've
done here right that in the event that
they're that the the main person dies
right so say you're infected by one of
these teleonics uh you basically become
holy that plant life right you lose your
own real identity here but in the event
that you die what would happen is you
would basically kind of reconstitute
yourself inside your own corpse and then
emerge at some future point in time
right almost like a like a butterfly out
of a cocoon except you know not really
pretty like like pretty ugly and and
nasty looking but that's what happens
across the board here right it's very
similar to the Xenomorphs from the alien
stories but they kind of start popping
up out of all these corpses right just
kind of popping up all over the place
and that's when things start you know
sort of pop off because from their
perspective they do what is inherently
in their nature which is to spread
across krakowa right so it's the events
of Beast kind of getting continually
worse now the other part of this is you
have Domino who shows up to Colossus and
for the most part for the character of
Colossus with him being out right with
him being in the Savage land down in
Antarctica and being out and away from
kakawa that he's at a place of Peace
he's removed from all of this right he's
removed from everything he wants to be
left alone and so when domino shows up
and asks him to come back his response
is no like I I began as a farmer I'm
going to stay here as a farmer I'm just
going to and to enjoy this time that I
have go away and leave me alone I don't
want to be part of this whole X-Men
thing that you guys have anymore the
problem with this is that as things
begin to pop off in krakowa the various
madroxes that Jamie had I'm sorry that
Colossus had on his farm who were
basically farmhands immediately start
bolting towards the Gate of krakowa and
that's when Colossus realizes some
things going on here right and so of
course he basically you know activates
his osmium skin and goes taking off
towards the the gates as well leaving
what looks like his girlfriend Kayla
behind or a sister or something like
that I don't think we're really given a
whole lot of information about this
character but he basically leaves her
behind and when he gets in there
everything's popping off this sentient
island is literally going nuts right
like these little things are like little
evil Pixies right they're like running
around with these little guns they got
little knives stabbing the hell out of
people and these things are maybe like
two feet tall but they're causing all
kinds of havoc on this place right like
just little evil Pixies just ripping the
whole place up now of course this leads
to Black Tom Cassidy showing up to
Xavier and basically saying like we're
locking you away right so it's like
taking the president to a bunker uh
while that's happening one of these
little guys manages to kind of sneak
away and basically accesses one of the
swords from swords of X right from
basically accesses the cerebral sword
and so he effectively takes off with it
and then from there like Colossus shows
up helps to overcome this gravy cues
thing kind of saves the day and then
leaves right it's just like I'm done
right you know and that's the crazy
thing is you gotta have this this sort
of conversation between uh between you
know Domino and Colossus where he's like
after I'm done with this like do not
come back and find me that's kind of
thing they had a little bit of a romance
to a degree but now he's done right he's
done with her he's done with the X-Men
the whole nine yards you know and he's
like do not come and find me right like
do not come back leave me alone and so
he basically just ends up leaving like
he just ends up kind of going off and
doing his own thing switch over to
Clinton Choir by Clinton choir is kind
of making out with uh Sophie from the
stuff for Cuckoos it's good to see that
he got one of those girls but the funny
thing is as soon as that happens he's
immediately stabbed and then he's
knocked through the portal by one of the
guys now here's the thing a lot of
people who are fans of Clinton choir
right like all 30 of them they're
probably pretty pissed off the Clinton
choirs being killed being killed and
kind of throw away throwing away like
this honestly I'm a fan of Clinton choir
but I'm biting my time because here's
the thing I feel like Quentin's gonna
have this ridiculously op moment right I
feel like it's kind of kind of slapping
him around a little bit and then just
giving him this ridiculously amazing
moment later on down the line because
remember he's an Omega Level telepath
right he's not Easy Pickins but when
he's knocked through here he's
immediately met by the arrival of
Mikhail Rasputin right the brother of
Colossus and we end up finding out that
the brother of Colossus is the one who's
leading this whole secretive
organization or at least involved in
this whole secretive organization now
Mikhail Rasputin is strange because
Marvel has never fully fleshed out what
his powers are we know that he can kind
of transmute matter on different levels
but it happens in different ways right
he can travel through time and space or
he can like change a person's body
structure right to change them into
something else it's one of these things
where it's kind of like matter
manipulation but only as it pertains to
like another person's physical body and
like his ability to move through time
and space but it's one of these things
where Marvel kind of keeps him in kind
of this gray area where it's like could
he become a reality manipulator or is he
kind of confined to this thing we don't
really know because we don't really care
because we've never taken the time to
tell you hey that's kind of what it is
that's kind of what what's going on with
this character but regardless he ends up
dragging him into what looks like the
Kremlin right so like the capital of of
uh the Russian government and that's
when it kind of when you get this this
sort of switchover where the main
henchman right of this guy of you know
the the leader who is at one point
defeated by you know the of the Xeno
group basically who was defeated by
Mikhail Rasputin is basically brought
back right he's kind of Resurrection he
doesn't really matter it's not really a
major talking point he's kind of
enhanced a little bit right like each
time he dies there's modifications that
are made to him to improve on the way
you know to improve on him so he doesn't
die that same way again or that he can
stand a better chance ah but as soon as
Mikhail Rasputin walks in here like one
he's been attending all these meetings
they they've been holding this meeting
from Michaela Rasputin right so they
kept it hidden and then in turn you also
have like Omega Red who's Uncle KOA as
well right kind of a quick little thing
but like this this big attack kind of
happens this kind of big assault happens
between Mikhail and this henchman guy
this symptom guy is overcome pretty
easily but the important thing that kind
of comes out of this is that one Mikhail
Rasputin turns into stone and destroys
him and then two you have this
conversation where uh where where
because it's Michaela Rasputin and
because the X-Men learn about this that
Beast goes after Colossus again and then
brings Colossus Back to the Island but
what's happened is B seems to have kind
of told everybody what was going on and
that pisses off Wolverine who basically
attacks beasts and it's just kind of
like dude you dick he chases everybody
out of there and they end up taking
Colossus to kind of a a sort of not
really an interrogation space kind of an
interrogation space but basically says
like look we have some questions that we
need to ask you about your brother
Mikhail and about about everything you
can tell us right like what you can tell
us about him his involvement your
familiar with highs what it is that he's
doing here the important thing is that
we kind of get an answer from Benjamin
Percy on this that Mikhail Rasputin
basically hands this weapon over to the
head of Zeno and says look the time has
come for you guys to accept the way
things are for the longest time you and
the various organizations who have
existed out there are the ones that came
before you have fought against mutant
kind on your own you fought against the
mutant population by yourself but that
doesn't work right you've built me an
army you've given me everything that I
needed but my resources are also now
your resources if we are going to take
down the mutant population we have to
work together you have to accept help
from mutant kind and so what this means
is the brother of Colossus has Allied
himself with an organization that seeks
the purpose of Bringing Down the X-Men
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are picking back up again with X of
Swords we are are getting into part two
right and it's one of the things we
talked about in EXO swords creation this
is a massive storyline right it's 22
parts and it spans the entirety of the X
books right all the X-Men related books
Excalibur and one of them for six
caliber but I think it includes
Excalibur but like X-Force and X Factor
which is what we're covering here uh
Wolverine all that kind of stuff so what
we end up doing here is picking up in
the direct aftermath of extra swords
creation right like apocalypse basically
being impaled and Richter you know more
or less being killed right and and he's
Richter's not really dead per se but
like both of them are severely injured
an apocalypse showing up here he's still
somewhat alive but it's kind of a weird
thing because apocalypse's Powers when
it comes to his abilities really kind of
wax and wanes depending on who's telling
the story right technically speaking
apocalypse should and and historically
did have total control of the atomic
structure of his body right I mean he
could heal himself from anything in this
instance he can't or he's unable to
we're not really given a clear
explanation as to why this isn't really
happening in turn him just kind of
healing himself super fast and going
back to normal but the idea of
Apocalypse healing himself also kind of
ran counter-intuitive to the nature of
Apocalypse in the sense that every some
period of time he would go into like an
incubation chamber and he would
basically kind of restore his energies
now again that was one of the
conflicting aspects of his character
Marvel played it fast and loose right
they said like apocalypse is a guy who's
just super powerful then you get into
like the the early 90s late 80s early
90s and it's like well apocalypse has to
like jump from one host body to the next
because his powers are too extreme and
then you go into like the early 2000s
and it's like actually he doesn't and
it's just it's it's weird the way that
Marvel's played with his powers over the
years but the idea here is that once
they arrive uh you know you you
basically end up having like like siren
he just calls out right just calls out
for help and you have like a whole host
of X-Men who show up you've got these
two shows up here you've got Rachel
Summers you have what looks like Dr
Reyes you have like a whole bunch of
people who were just showing up here
right and the first thing that
apocalypse tells Richter is not to die
right that a mutant always fights and in
this instance Richter has to continue
basically fighting for his life the
other part of this is that with Polaris
showing back up she comes with the
unwelcoming news that of course
rockslide has been killed and that's one
of the things that kind of takes her
takes her in a pretty rough ways because
one she watched him die two she brought
his remains back and three that
rockslide is one of the younger members
of the X-Men team right and so in a lot
of ways it it makes Polaris feel as
though she personally failed and so what
ends up happening here is that in
response to everything going on one of
the things that saturnin does and a lot
of people say it's it's Saturn nine no
it's not it's saturnine so what ends up
happening is Saturday and basically like
waves her hand and ends up destroying
the external gate ah that allows people
from cocoa to enter into a Rocco now
remember this was not supposed to happen
that kakoa the island itself did not
want to see this gate destroyed under
any circumstance the fact that it's been
done pisses the island off in the most
extreme right now of course the
rationale is given to krakowa is we
weren't the ones who did it right it was
totally saturnin it's on her she's the
one that made the call in other world
there's nothing we can really do right
the power that she possesses there by by
the virtue of the magic she used is
beyond our ability to overcome right
she's more or less almost kind of like a
goddess in her own realm and so in
response to that what you've had here is
you've had a couple people who have
tried to enter into the subconscious
mind of Polaris in order to access the
riddle right the prophecy that was given
to her by saturnin and the first person
to do it of course was Monet Saint Croix
she tried to enter into uh polaris's
mind it didn't work then came Rachel
Summer she tried the exact same thing
every time they do it triggers this kind
of automated uh telepathic trap where
saturnin basically pops up and says Nope
you can't do that and then she takes him
away and throws him out of her mind and
it happens every single time they try
now this in and of itself is a pretty
astronomical feat and it's something to
be easy to dismiss right it's starting
to be easy to throw away but something
to understand here Rachel Summers is an
Omega Level telepath she's not small
beans she's not someone who's just kind
of coming along and reading surface
thoughts and just managed to muster
enough power to get into the
subconscious mind of of Polaris and then
try to find a way to crack this riddle
no she's super powerful she's been a
host of The Phoenix Force she fought
Galactus to a standstill and actually
actually like forced him off I mean it's
kind of crazy some of the things that
she's done over the course of her
history and to be overpowered by
saturnin especially on the telepathic
level where she's at her most powerful
actually pretty incredible like it's
it's kind of nuts the way that happens
but again from there we kind of switch
over to Richter and apocalypse and the
crazy thing about this is that you end
up having uh Richter who's not quite
dead and who could potentially be healed
by healer himself but ultimately healer
chooses not to instead like like when
apocalypse tells healer like 10 to the
boy the responsive healer is I have to
help you both and an apocalypse is kind
of like this guy's dying right like
Richter doesn't have the same kind of
power I have Richter's dying take to him
and then worry about me but at the end
of the day the Healer you know
apocalypse kind of picks up on what's
going on and says like you're gonna let
him die and the response of healer is
he'll be resurrected swiftly and then
apocalypse responds then join him and he
in turn goes to attack the Healer using
his telepathy and telekinesis now the
fact that he's gonna shut this guy down
he's gonna kill him in his entirety he's
immediately attacked by by basically a
combined forces right a telepath ends up
like attacking him now this initially
takes on the form of his four horsemen
right kind of using his own experiences
against him and then it takes on the
form of uh of Richter but the crazy
thing is that once that's done done we
end up finding out of course that it's
Rachel Summers who ended up doing that
right Rachel Summers ended up screwing
with him and basically ended up being
the one to kind of take Apocalypse Now
from there you end up going directly
into Polaris who kind of has this
conversation with with Charles Xavier
and these guys and you have the attempts
uh the attempts of of Xavier brilliant
and even the five to kind of bring back
Richter and to bring back rockslide and
the problem with this is that with
Richter returning and and rock slide
returning Richter seems to come back
without a hitch rock slide on the other
hand there's this kind of crazy massive
surge that goes on right this this kind
of thing where it's almost like a
psychic attack across you know all the
telepaths inside krakowa and even
attacks the the little you know the
various Gates that are there right those
little Resurrection pods and you know
the the different points right that kind
of pick up on Charles Xavier and so on
but Xavier passes out rockslard starts
kind of going nuts and babbling a whole
bunch of nonsense and and basically the
five end up shutting down all the
Resurrection Eggs and destroying them
all right because in their mind there's
something wrong with the Resurrection
Eggs when they brought rockslide back
and their initial kind of you know look
here when Polaris kind of looks at
rockslide is like you're not rock slide
the initial indication here is that he
brought something back right he was
contaminated with a virus so to speak
and that when he was resurrected that
virus kind of spread itself toward you
know and into the eggs and so when those
were all destroyed Xavier wakes up and
he starts freaking out he's like you
like what have you done you know and the
response is that's not rock slide and so
what you end up getting here is this
this idea of Xavier Reading the mind of
Richter to figure out if that's actually
Richter right to make sure the pro the
problem with rock slide doesn't repeat
itself and they're all kind of panicking
on what they do because they've never
had a situation where they've
resurrected someone and then I'll Hell
broke loose and they had to destroy the
little Resurrection X they've never
really had that before and so what it
does at least what it kicks into is it
it leads to a meeting of the quiet
Council of sorts right and what we end
up learning here is that we learn a
couple massive things that go on and
it's actually cool to see this and it
was really only a matter of time but
when it comes to the idea of X-Men or
mutants resurrecting each other there's
kind of a hitch in the giddy up here
that previously we kind of looked at
this as though you know Resurrection was
like an infinite thing you could
resurrect somebody an infinite number of
times and you can and but in this
instance there's a catch the idea is
that if you are in the main Marvel
Universe and you're a mutant who dies on
Earth somewhere you can be resurrected
an infinite number of times There's No
Limit there but if they die in other
world everything changes and the reason
why is because Otherworld is a Nexus of
realities right any possible reality can
be reached from that Nexus of realities
it's always been that way right ever
since the introduction of saturnin and
the old you know was it was it uh the
old Marvel Tales whatever it was number
380 the introduction of Roma Merlin has
always been established as being that
way the caveat to this is that because
it is a Nexus of reality if you die in
other world and you're resurrected
there's no guarantee that they'll
resurrect the person who died right it
could be any any one of those possible
versions of yourself out there
throughout the entirety of the
Multiverse so an example here is if we
take somebody like Wolverine uh if
Wolverine were to go into the uh go into
other world and he were to die and they
were to resurrect him they may end up
resurrecting the version of Wolverine
from like Age of Apocalypse or they may
end up resurrecting a version of
Wolverine from like Days of Future Past
right that personality would come with
him now the immediate response to that
is okay if the whole idea behind cerebro
is to constantly back up a person's
memory right so you back them up on day
one so you have day one day two day
three day four these are all files that
are constantly being backed up then why
not retrieve their memory or the
personality and everything that made
them who they are from like the day
before they ended up going into other
world now that's answered here too the
answer or the reason for that is because
with rockslide what we ended up seeing
here was that when he was brought back
and he was resurrected this kind of
virus or this kind of effect ended up
wiping out all the backups of his
character right now it threatened to
wipe out all the backups across the
entirety of krakowa but that was stopped
right but it basically destroys all your
previous backups so there's no way of
resurrecting you as the person you were
before what this means is that rockslide
cannot go back to being who he was it's
a way to kind of kill a character but
not kill a character at the same time
physically they would be dead but it
gives Marvel license to just recreate
characters on a whim right and so if
Marvel will create if Marvel goes and
they say oh okay here's what we're gonna
do with the character of Polaris right
we're gonna have this storyline with her
and we're gonna change her character up
in this way we're gonna do these things
and and fans don't like it then oh my
God some crazy event where she ended up
another world and she died time to bring
her back here's a new version who's
different from the last one do you guys
like this that's that's what Marvel can
do they can shift Up characters and
personalities you know on a whim
depending on how they write the stories
which is actually a great idea it's a
great way to kind of keep everybody
there and then change who they are
without having to like rework everything
or like reboot everything or anything on
those lines it's a really smart move the
other part of this though is that when
the questions asked of Polaris what have
you been doing to try to figure out this
riddle the response is well I'm I
haven't right like she hasn't she's been
basically grieving over Rock and
this pisses off Magneto because he
immediately starts yelling at her he's
like just figure out what the riddle is
and this triggers a kind of subconscious
reaction and so this prophecy as it's
given says As Above So Below from one
womb came to a hero destined to brandish
what the Earth has swallowed and an echo
doomed to yearn for what the Stars hath
foresworn lost soul and Edge game a lone
Wanderer returns to a forge left Ablaze
a Sword in the Stone stationed in space
a young man born old pilots a place a
father forsaken a husband betrayed an
ancient treasure sharpens the death his
children crave for himself friends lost
out of one comes many into many comes
one eight years gone in seconds from a
childhood loss comes a woman grown her
only friends were weapons now her soul
ablade hers alone once goddess once
Queen one sword with which to split the
sky in Twain vibranium inlaid a tempest
contain she is the wrath of Heavens
wielding a legacy ego death and broken
Stone two Wars waged by one Champion
alone and that's it right that's all we
really get for that prophecy now here's
my question you guys who do you think
those characters are referencing some
are obvious like cable and storm but
others I'm kind of curious about I think
one of those is hope but let me know
right because I mean that's the whole
idea behind the kind of beginning of
this is to give us each one of these
characters who are going to be wielding
these various weapons right like one of
them first a Wolverine in the muramasa
blade right like the the forge left and
all that kind of stuff that's that's the
muramasu blade right like the hellforge
basically but Polaris in response to
this after kind of running off this
prophecy not realizing what she did ends
up grabbing the remains of rockslide and
taking off now the other thing that
comes out of this is you have Xavier and
Magneto who appear to apocalypse and
their whole stance is okay so here's the
deal pops like your great experiment has
failed against the wishes of the council
you took this team and you took it into
Morocco believing that you could achieve
whatever you needed to achieve and this
led to basically a loss of mutant life
and as a result of that the death of
these mutants are on your head at the
end of the day right now the
Resurrection The Resurrection Stones
Resurrection Garden whatever you want to
call it it's currently offline and it
will stay that way like Xavier tells
them you chose not to heed the council
and now your hubris has basically doomed
to solve you've entered us into a
conflict that we could potentially lose
and if we do it'll lead to the death of
everybody on krakowa it'll lead to the
eradication of the mutant population and
I dare say the Conquering of the world
and depending on what level they possess
even you know what level of power they
have possibly even further further
Beyond and so they're like you know you
won't be resurrected anytime soon right
like you're suffering the consequences
of your actions you better hope you
don't die because if you do we're not
going to bring you back anytime soon not
only that I doubt anybody will grieve
your absence right it's kind of a crazy
thing because despite the fact that
apocalypse is still on or it really is
on the quiet Council it kind of shows
that there really isn't a lot of love
lost between Xavier Magneto and
apocalypse right like you know he's
there because they respect the role he
plays and the power he has and the
experience he brings to the table but
they still don't like him right and so
what you end up getting here is is kind
of the next morning sort of the rise of
the Sun and you've got Polaris who
basically created this kind of like
these all these little sigils right this
kind of platform and she used the
remains of rock slide to do it kind of
looking at this as what is essentially a
kind of Testament that will stand
Eternal to the memory of rockslide but
what this is designed to do is is
basically be a kind of Gathering Place
right in the sense that those
individuals who gather their swords will
bring them here they'll bring their here
they'll bring them here they'll stand
there with their swords or place their
swords and when everything is brought
together then the the beginning of the
conflict will commence right and so at
this point right now in X of Swords all
we're doing is following the stories of
various characters as they're locating
their weapons they're locating their
their respective weapons their swords
and then bringing them to this location
and so next up is Wolverine and the
muramasa blade and the coolest thing
about this Wolverine's gonna go to hell
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are picking back up again
with X of Swords this time the Wolverine
story and we're focusing on part three
now here's the thing here's a cool thing
I like about EXO swords this is a
throwback to the way that Marvel used to
do Comics back in the 1990s when they
did major crossover events only this
time it's a lot more organized
uh back in the day a little bit of
History here for those of you guys who
are unfamiliar with this back in the day
at least when I started reading comics
and even like before the 1990s they did
this but back in the day you didn't
really have numbered crossover events in
DC Comics you had like you did have that
with like Crisis on infinite Earth but
that was such a big event that at the
time that's what made it so one of the
things that made it so Landmark was like
it was the crisis on infinite events
store or crash on infinite her story you
did have like Crisis on Earth One crisis
on Earth two uh that really came long
before that right back in the 60s I
think but the cool thing or what was
interesting is that back then in the 90s
you would have a crossover event that
would just span a whole bunch of
individual comic book lines right so
imagine now when you have crossovers
except you don't have a main story so
like Civil War If Civil War happened
over the course of a bunch of individual
character or team comics and didn't have
a core story like Civil War one two
three four all the way up to seven or
however many issues that it was that's
how it was done back then this is much
is done very much the same way you have
what's basically the Omega and the alpha
a comic which is how they used to do it
back in the 90s right so like X of
Swords creation number one is the
equivalent to the 1990s like EXO swords
Alpha and then when you get to the very
end and be like EXO swords Omega the
kind of opening issue and the closing
issue right and everything just kind of
Falls in between and I kind of like this
right it's an old throwback it's it's
kind of cool the way that it used to be
but from there uh really the way this
kind of kicks off is you basically pick
up with Wolverine Wolverine basically
emerging out of the pits of hell now how
he got here will be explained over this
um it's not really required that you
read the first five issues of Wolverine
you can if you want to but that largely
deals with the blood of Wolverine being
taken by vampires and handed over to
their leader Dracula so the vampires can
walk around in the day and the night and
that's basically it Omega Red has a role
in that but it's by no means the most
important thing ever and if I'm being
kind of honest a little bit lackluster
for an opening Wolverine story arc to be
quite Frank but this initially kicks off
with with Wolverine kind of emerging
from you're kind of merging out of the
pits of hell and making this kind of
comment about how you know for a lot of
people going to hell and back is just an
expression but for Wolverine he's done
it more than once but the problem is
that you know for from Wolverines
perspective the hell is a place where
basically your past catches up with you
and for the mutant population the pass
is catching up with krakowa and that's
where you kind of have Wolverine talking
to Cocoa itself and basically saying
like at the end of the day like your own
your voice here is the only one that
really matters but the reality of this
is that you've been in existence ever
since the creation of really kind of the
splitting of this home Island right and
so now you have Morocco and you have
krakowa and the issue with this is that
you wanted that external gate to stay
open because you knew it would
ultimately lead to war right maybe some
kind of reunification but you knew War
would happen at some point during that
process I.E you wanted War the thing to
understand is I will play my part here I
will go track down the muramasa blade
like I'm supposed to but just know this
I don't trust you and I never will right
I don't see you as a trustworthy being
and so what you end up getting here is
kind of Wolverine giving us this little
bit of a flashback right like his wife
itsu the death of itsu the belief that
his son had died as well of course his
son being Dakin who didn't die and kind
of went on to to be raised accordingly
link with the reworking of Wolverine's
origin which I never completely agreed
with but you also end up having him
visiting Ken harada and the reason why
is because Wolverine wants to know uh
where muramasa is right like where is
muramasa gone to now the funny thing
about miramasa himself he's fashioned
different weapons and arms and Armament
over the course of his life and he's
been around for hundreds of years the
belief is that muramasa is Immortal but
it was never actually confirmed by
Marvel Comics that he is an immortal
character instead like he's basically
vanished here and the concern of
Wolverine is where his muramasa gone now
the significance of the muramasa blade
is twofold the first is a fact that of
course it's one of the swords that has
to be hunted for and used during this
major conflict that saturnin set in
motion but the other thing that's
important here is that the muramasa
blade has the ability to nullify healing
factors the idea is that you could use
the muramasa blade to basically cut
through Wolverine and then so I cut his
head off and then remove like put the
two pieces in two different locations
right that was the Xavier protocols to
effectively keep Wolverine dead to
separate his head from his body and to
never reunify the two because he cannot
grow back ahead right he would just stay
dead for however long that happens to be
but Ken harada is a silver samurai is a
person is probably the best person to
start with because it's silver samurai
right between his knowings about the
comings and goings in Japan his
swordsmanship his times with harada I'm
sorry with that with muramasa he's the
person to start with and so initially
Ken harad is kind of pissed because he
feels like he should have been the one
to be tasked with tracking down the
muramasa blade of course it makes sense
into a bee Wolfram right because
Wolverine was the one who commissioned
the blade to be made in the first place
that when his wife itsu had been killed
that combined with all the experiences
he had gone through before led to him
going to muramasa and saying I need you
to craft a blade for me so that if I use
it I can make God bleed and ultimately
it took a whole bunch of years to make
this sword but when it was done it was a
sword that could kill virtually anybody
right there really isn't anybody out
there that can survive being decapitated
by the sword or something like that now
at the end of the day you end up having
Wolverine of course who gets the upper
hand on uh on Silver Samurai and then
says like tell me what you know and
that's when harada says all I know are
rumors now at this point we switch over
to oracco right to the Tower of what's
called broken will and we're basically
following the horsemen War here and what
we end up getting is that there's a
person put inside this this Temple of
broken will who's been here for a
hundred years right well it's 100 years
in a season so however long a season is
down here in in uh in iroco but
basically a hundred years and that this
person was tasked here or put here
because of the fact that this being had
basically killed the husband of War
somewhere along the line and so we end
up finding out that this person who's
here is a guy by the name of solemn and
the Hope or the belief was that in the
time that he's been here he would have
lost his mind he would have basically
gone crazy but the funny thing about
this is Solemn is a sane as ever right
he's insane as he as he's ever been
because while he was trapped down in
this tower that was designed to break
his will and to drive him insane the
people who were supportive of him have
actually been providing him with gifts
and different things like that now the
motivation for solemn killing Bracken
the husband of war is never fully given
to us instead we're kind of given what
are basically a series of speculations
that people don't really seem to know
that all Solomon has is what's basically
kind of like a self-professed agenda
right in the sense that he he is a
person who enjoys gamesmanship right so
he's he's a lot like the Grand Master
from from Marvel Comics but his loyalty
isn't to anybody but himself right it's
just music flesh and wine and that's
basically it sometimes blood right
really nothing more than that but the
idea was that Bracken who was the
husband of War and the father of
Summoner that the indication is that the
ability of of solemn to kind of seduce
other people came to bear with his
ability to seduce Bracken right so
effectively he was a he was you know had
dabbled in uh in being gay right and and
being with guys and so the result of
this is that the kind of speculation
comes into play and the sense of this
believed that the possibility was there
that the whole goal of solemn was to
actually seduce War but it couldn't be
done and so the result was that solemn
seduced Bracken and then killed him in
order to get back at war or maybe that
he had made an advantage a kind of an
advancement towards war and War rebuked
it whatever the case is you know we
don't really know right all we really
know is that for whatever reason he
killed Bracken and that kind of led him
to this place the other part of this is
that that war had presented him
presented as solemn with basically the
hellblade right the the blade of bracken
in the hopes that having this in its
possession and then losing his mind
would lead to him basically killing
himself right and he would be sent
directly to hell but none of that really
seems to have happened and in fact war
is kind of shocked to the fact that none
of it really seemed to happen right and
so with this with this kind of going
down the way that it was uh you end up
having them basically approaching
Solomon saying like the reason why we're
here is because you have to track down
the muramasa blade right like normally
we would leave you here or we might even
kill you ourselves right but the funny
thing about this is that solemn appears
to be an unkillable character right he
seems to be seems to be someone that
nobody out there can kill and so the
result is that they end up freeing him
and basically say like you need to go
and find the muramasa blade right like
that's the whole point that's what you
have to do and so Solem effectively kind
of goes on his mission right he's got
three days to do it and it's like okay
then like let's let's go do this right
and so from there you pick back up with
Wolverine kind of jumping a little bit
between the past and the present some of
this and in terms of stuff in the past
is really designed to kind of flesh out
things that for the most part if you
been reading Wolverine for any measure
of time you already knew but if you're
new to Wolverine you wouldn't really
know a lot of that stuff right but it's
basically just this idea that itsu had
been killed and that Wolverine went on a
warpath trying to find muramasa in a way
to basically enact his revenge right
that he had an exceedingly violent life
he was basically kind of a killer for
hire and then when he met itsu that it
basically kind of brought him back and
and really calmed him down right it
showed him that he could have a life
outside of this violent life that he'd
been living and losing her kind of
solidified this idea to Logan that like
he could never actually find peace that
peace would always elude him for the
rest of his life and so in his anger and
in his Vengeance he ended up tracking
down muramasa and essentially having
muramasa create a blade for him the
other thing that kind of comes out of
this is you end up having What's called
the hand that when he eventually located
muramas or at least he went to travel
back to see him at some point in time
muramasa had basically been killed in
kind of a ritual sacrifice by the hand
and ultimately sent to what was
basically hell and so in the moment and
the kind of present moment where
Wolverine basically emerges from Hell
itself this is basically the journey he
went on right that the rumors that can
harada hit her heard where that muramasa
had basically been sent to hell or was
operating in hell as an agent of the
hand and that Wolverine effectively had
to travel there in order to find
muramasa right so that's why he just
kind of wakes up in the pits here but
the hand is an interesting Concept in
Marvel right and we've talked about them
before the hand as most of you guys know
it's like a mystical ninja Clan but
there's a little more to them than that
back in the day in in feudal Japan uh
you had uh you know the the kind of
Japanese empire as it existed but what
you also had were farmers and and people
out there who didn't want to be part of
Japanese the the Japanese empire and so
what they did is they took to the
mountainsides and they started
practicing different forms of martial
arts that were outside of the approval
of the Japanese empire but what you
ended up getting were they were all kind
of split and kind of you know broken and
fractured and so on that you had a guy
named kaganobu yoshioka who basically
brought them all together he unified the
entirety of the hand following that the
group started worshiping what was called
the beast and that led to the hand kind
of adopting a lot of these mystical
abilities ended becoming the super
mystical ninja organization out there
right these are the guys who could kill
you in a locked room and nobody would
know how it happened right that's that's
what's kind of crazy about these about
these guys and so Wolverine basically
emerges from this pit right emerges from
this pit finally finds muramasa and
muramasa's response is you have to save
me you have to get me out of here
because as in in essence muramasa is
working for the hand and by extension is
working for a demon right so it's like
Wolverine versus basically like the
demon of hell
okay so we are picking back up with uh
swords of X and in this one we're
covering part four which features
X-Force which is just kind of a
continuation of the video the the last
video that we did we were talking about
Wolverine right and in the last video
Wolverine was on the hunt for muramasa
right he was traveling around he's been
about 24 hours doing it trying to find
this guy because it was his task to
locate and use the muramasa blade as
part of the swords of X event the thing
about this is that everybody that he
talked to had basically told him that
muramasa had essentially become a
servant of the hand which was kind of a
something that Wolverine just couldn't
really get behind right because muramasa
never really seemed to be the kind of
person that would serve the hand but
ultimately locating this yomi Temple
that celebrated the underworld he ended
up finding that muramasa had kind of
been sacrificed in this sort of ritual
sacrifice that that had basically taken
him to the hand or at least been done by
the hand and that's when Wolverine's
completely and totally ambushed right
now the thing about the hand we've
talked about this before because they
use the attack and massive drones right
they attack in just a huge overwhelming
number basically means that anybody they
go again isn't really going to have much
of a chance to defeat them now uh with
regards to facing off against Wolverine
they can hold their own well than you
know more than enough right because
they're here to achieve a particular
goal now when Wolverine rips the mask
off one of the members of the hand they
don't look the way they used to in the
sense of the hand always look like
people because they effectively were
people but the idea is that Wolverines
basically taken by the hand themselves
once he's stabbed and thrown in you know
thrown through a kind of portal that
leads directly to what is essentially
hell now hella Marvel Comics and we've
talked about this before the hell of
Marvel Comics is kind of like is a
geographical place right and you can
kind of split it up based on different
territories right and so if we said if
we use the United States as an example
which is not that far-fetched and we
said the United States is hell then in
turn what we could do is we could say
like California is ruled by Mephisto and
Washington DC is ruled by like you know
Damon hellstrom and Florida is ruled by
somebody else right that is all kind of
broken up into these different sections
Marvel's never really Consolidated this
that never really answered the question
like what stops the soul in the realm of
Mephisto from wandering into the soul of
Damon hellstrom and has this kind of you
know unification and splitting of
factions among hell were right it Marvel
never really clarify that they kind of
have a little bit to a degree here and
there but by and large we don't really
have a kind of like map in terms of how
hell is laid out and how this
determining Factor on who rules what
section how it's all kind of solidified
but the long and short of this is that
this is how Wolverine ended up in hell
and basically caught himself out when he
was moving you know and just was nothing
more than an adamantium skeleton now one
of you guys asked the question how it is
that Wolverine can move when he's only a
skeleton comic book logic guys because
you're not wrong right you're not wrong
if you say that doesn't make any sense
no person who's just simply a skeleton
could move because there's no no muscle
no nerves none of that stuff none of the
components of the body needs in order to
be able to move right I mean your
muscles push and pull and that's how you
move and you know move one leg in front
of the other right in order to walk in a
forward Direction without that you can't
move you would just be laying there
right so kind of look logic just kind of
take it for what it is but that's when
he's kind of set upon the hand as they
kind of exist here right as they exist
in this this sort of new realm you know
they're he's met by basically demons and
so on and all the while you have
muramasa crafting swords for for the
Beast now the Beast is a character that
the hand basically worship and the Beast
is largely responsible for the hand's
mystical abilities right the ability to
resurrect the dead different things like
that but the funny thing about it is
that the Beast location which is to say
the dimension in which he resides had
never been fully fleshed out in Marvel
Comics and the fact that this is in Hell
really basically shows us the Beast is
one of the hell Lords that are out there
right he's one of these demonic entities
that resides in the realm of hell and
presumably has his own little location
now we don't really know anything about
it but whatever the situation is
muramasa has been brought here because
he is viewed as being owed a debt to the
Beast and the reason for that comes in
the nature of muramasa in the sense that
when when he's crafting a weapon he's
the greatest Craftsman in all onion on
all of earth right he's the greatest
weapons maker on Earth itself but one of
the things that makes him so interesting
is that he can actually take a portion
or all of your soul and put it inside
the weapon he creates and what this has
been viewed as by the Beast and
presumably other demonic entities is
that he robbed them of souls right
beings who maybe maybe like they made
some kind of a pack with Mephisto and
and Mephisto would take their soul when
they die but instead they end up having
their soul placed inside the muramasa
blade their physical body will die but
their soul will be put what kind of
exists inside this blade and they'll
never actually go to the realm of
Mephisto right so he was kind of cheated
out of a bargain so to speak where
muramasa doesn't really ask too many
questions he doesn't really he doesn't
really have a checklist right like okay
uh please check off the demon entities
Who Sold you oh it doesn't really work
that way and so he doesn't really know
but the result of this is that he's
being viewed as owing a debt and that's
why he's currently a servant of the
Beast because the Beast is making good
on the death that he feels he's owed now
for Wolverine himself he's basically
thrown inside of one of the cells in
hell and when that happens his body of
course kind of starts you know regrowing
you know his bones and or at least his
uh skeleton and you know muscles and all
that kind of stuff kind of starts going
through that whole process but he's met
with the arrival of solemn now solemn of
course as most of you guys remember we
saw in the last video and this was a guy
who was contacted by by the horsemen war
and basically told you have to go in
grab one of the muramasa blades or a
blade from muramasa in order to satisfy
your role as one of the people who are
going to be fighting against the heroes
of krakowa right as part of this extra
swords event and so he basically ends up
kind of going on his journey and and
traveling and getting to that location
now how was it he actually got here to
hell but it's kind of given to us in a
bit of a flashback in the sense that he
kind of tells Wolverine while his body's
restructuring it basically tells
Wolverine that at some point along the
line once he left the island of a really
the land of Morocco he ended up
traveling to travel and see the Oracle
of Morocco and the Oracle have been
placed there kind of banished there by
her sister and the result was that
Solomon essentially cut this girl's head
off and then brought it to the Oracle
and was like here's the payment that I
offer as tribute for this kind of
Prophecy this you know direction that I
need to go in right because it requires
some kind of tribute in order for you to
get information from the Oracle and so
the Oracle basically tells him like you
are going to have to travel to the realm
of hell and you have the the tools you
need to do it right the muramas is
currently currently dead you cannot go
and find him on Earth but what you have
in your possession this hellblade that
you possess is a heat it will allow you
to access health but know that when you
go there you're not going to be able to
find muramasa on your own instead you're
going to have to seek out the man made
of metal and he will be your guide to
muramasa hence the reason why solemn's
here because he needs Wolverine in order
to find muramasa and so the funny thing
is that once Wolverine emerges once he
kind of Pops back and he's totally
healed he uses his adamantium and tries
to cut through the hell for his bars and
it doesn't work and this is one of only
a handful of instances in Marvel Comics
when we're basically given a material
that's stronger than adamantium right by
and large adamantium is the strongest
material in Marvel Comics right there
are a couple things out there that might
be stronger than adamantium something
like like Thor's hammer but even within
the Marvel Universe nothing can really
cut through adamantium or at least only
one thinking could really cut through
adamantium but it is essentially highly
durable it can't really be destroyed
when it starts out in a liquid state
once it hardens and solidifies it can't
be returned back to a liquid state again
there are different kind of weaknesses
out there something like anti-metal
right so if you had like an anti-metal
blade it could cut through uh um sorry
adamantium not in the traditional sense
but because anti-metal breaks down metal
on the atomic level so it's almost kind
of like you're you're cutting through it
without actually touching it if that
makes any sense but you know this is one
of these instances where we've
encountered yet something else in Marvel
that's stronger than adamantium and so
what you end up getting is this attempt
by Wolverine to kind of take out solemn
right because if the stance of solemn is
I'm here to get the muramasa blade and
Wolverines here for the same thing then
ultimately they would end up fighting
over the sword right so Wolverines like
I'll just kill you now and I won't have
to worry about it later but when he goes
to to attack solemn we end up finding
the reason why solemn is kind of
considered to be this indestructible man
is because his skin is actually made of
adamantium but at the moment he and
Wolverine effectively have to work
together right Wolverine can't kill him
and he needs Wolverine and so with that
happening they basically set off into
the hellforge itself right into the
realm of the Beast and once they locate
him there's this kind of ceremony taking
place right this marriage between what
he calls his left his red left hand and
his red right hand right seemingly his
two most devoted servants and so as this
marriage is taking place this is why
these swords of muramas were being
created right they were being done for
the purpose of honoring this kind of
ritual not only that he put the entirety
of his soul into these swords right he
says for you I put my very Soul into
them right and so what this does is it
leads to uh you know as part of this
ritual it leads to the Beast basically
instructing his servants to kill
muramasa and then to basically absorb
his soul into the swords themselves now
whether or not this means muramasa can
come back we don't really know right it
may be one of these things where the the
soul is stuck inside the swords and will
never see it again right muramasa is
dead for all time we're not entirely
sure here but what we do know is that
with his soul being absorbed into the
swords it makes them wildly powerful in
the sense that when you have uh solemn
launching his attack and destroying one
of the red hands that this leads to the
to the other one attacking him and in
doing so he starts to bleed and that's
when the Revelation is given to him on
behalf of Wolverine the muramasa blades
can cut through adamantium that's their
purpose but the original muramasu blade
was created or at least done by
Wolverine with a portion of his soul
placed inside so that the sword itself
could cut through Wolverines adamantium
and behead him if it needed to be done
and so with that being the case all
blades coming after have the ability to
cut through adamantium right so it's
basically a means by which Wolverine and
solemn can kill each other because the
question leading up to this was that if
these two are going to end up doing
battle solemn's skin is made of
adamantium and Wolverine's bones are
made of adamantium how could they ever
really kill each other right they would
just fight for all eternity but the fact
that they're blades that are able to cut
through this material means they can
kill each other and that's where the
questions kind of ask that the Beast is
killed pretty quickly which is a little
disappointing but the question that's
asked by Solomon is why should I give
you this sword why do that I have both
katanas uh you know I've I killed both
the bride and the groom I could just
take them for myself but it's the nature
of the extra swords event that Wolverine
needs a sword and that solemn needs a
sword and seemingly solemn is a person
who is very much honor bound right he
believes that if they are going to fight
each other they're going to duel in the
most honorable way possible and so what
he tells Wolverine is I will give you
this sword but I want a deal I want
something in return what this thing is
we don't know instead all we end up
getting next is Wolverine emerging you
know into into krakowa bringing his
sword with him simply saying that he got
a sore but it came with a price and then
taking his place on the altar as one of
the heroes who have attained their
swords from the extra sword event
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are continuing on with the
swords of X event this time we are into
part 5 and we are picking up with the
marauder specifically storm and I like
the way this goes down initially this
kind of thing opens up with storm
meeting with Kitty Pride who of course
Kitty pride is more or less the leader
of the Marauders team and the whole idea
with storm is she's currently struggling
with the fact that she has to basically
acquire her own sword that storm is one
that has to grab one of the swords
specifically a sword from wakanda and
this is not something as easily said or
easily done as it is said right because
Kitty quad kind of offers her Aid and
storm says no this is something that I
have to do on my own right and the
reason for this is given to us in uh in
a little bit of the history here in
wakanda itself what we're basically
given here is this idea that in the
early days of wakandan History one of
the things that we're told is that in
the early days of wakanda when vibranium
first showed up there the people didn't
really know what to make of it but they
didn't really know what to make of this
great Mound this giant asteroid composed
of vibranium that landed on Earth but
when wakandans eventually moved or
really kind of settled in the territory
and started focusing and kind of
building their empire around vibranium
it originated with the creation of what
was called the sky breaker and this was
basically a sword that was the the first
weapon crafted out of vibranium which
basically crushed the enemies that were
going against wakanda the benefit of
this came in the recognition of the
potential this sword had specifically
what vibranium had and so wakandans
began studying vibranium more and more
and the more they studied it the more
they realized how unique it was among
other metals across the face of the
Earth this led to the desire for
vibranium which led to countries and and
so on willing to pay top dollar to get
their hands on it and by being able to
pay her or being so willing to pay so
much money for it this is how wakanda
Rose to prominence that because
vibranium was so expensive wakanda used
these resources to fund the building of
their cities they use this money to fund
the education of its people that kind of
thing it's a pretty genius idea in terms
of how it works but more so than that
the sky breaker is passed on from Chief
to Chief but more so and what's really
important here is the sky breaker is
kind of a symbol of the wakandan people
right it's their equivalent of like the
Holy Bible Bible for for Christianity
right it's the religious concept
something that you simply just don't
mess with or maybe the cross is
something more it's that's probably a
better example but the longest word of
this is Storm basically shows up to
wakanda itself right now t'challa is
kind of out doing t'challa stuff doing
black panther stuff right he's just
doing his black panther Lee duties and
it takes him away from wakanda
temporarily and so she ends up meeting
with shuri and the Queen Mother and one
of the unspoken things about the the
history of storm here is that as most of
you guys know storm was married to
t'challa at one point in time right he
basically nullified their marriage I
think during the events of Avengers
versus X-men but they really haven't
been married ever since right their
relationship is a little stronger than
it used to be and they're kind of
getting back onto good terms to a degree
but marriage doesn't really seem
anything that's going to be happening
anytime soon and we get this really
succinct you know kind of explanation
here which is one of the things that I
like about Vita Aya is he he explains it
in a way to where it's really really
it's done really clearly right and
really easily when Queen Mother asks
what in the world is going on the
response of storm is okay so apocalypse
had his four horsemen they were
basically banished to this place called
Iraq and they eventually formed an army
they invaded Otherworld and by accessing
Otherworld they want to lead this Army
into the rest of the Multiverse starting
with our universe and kill us all done
the plot to acts of Swords that's
that's the entire gist of it and it's
cool right this is one of the reasons
why I like it when there are other
tie-ins to Jonathan Hickman's story
right because a lot of you guys know
Hickman he's an amazing writer I love
him to death right I love the work he
does but he can sometimes make his
stories a little over confusing in terms
of how he writes and and it's easier
when somebody else kind of looks at it
and then just breaks it down in a more
digestible way right because it's very
easy to get kind of get caught up and
everything that Hickman's doing because
not everything gets explained right off
the bat so it kind of leaves you sort of
wondering a little bit but the cool
thing about this is that when when storm
tells them this that this this is a
Potential Threat to to the world the
response of wakanda is did Will Will
assemble an army right we will make an
army and we will we will help you fight
alongside this battle and Storm's idea
is no I can't necessarily do that I need
a weapon specifically a weapon from
wakanda one with history and so that's
when you start getting things like the
nation maker the panther claws the
king's Mercy right these different
swords that black panther and different
weapons of black panther have used over
the course of the entire history of
wakanda but storm yet again turns this
down and says no I need the sky breaker
and that's when the response is that's
not possible that's not something that
we can just give you right we can't just
hand you this weapon over it could lead
to the disaster our people would Riot
right because it would be wakanda giving
away its most religious figure that more
more and it's kind of interesting the
more that Marvel covers the history of
wakanda the more they they involve
wakanda and and the rest of the
goings-on and Crossovers and whatnot the
more you learn about wakanda's culture
and so we get this explanation here that
because the sky breaker is such an
important figure in the history of
wakanda right is the weapon that was
used to solidify the wakanda nature that
is not something you just give a person
right it's like the Declaration of
Independence or the United States
Constitution you don't just hand it over
to somebody else right this is something
that you keep protected under lock and
key and that the belief the faith of the
wakanan people is so revered in terms of
this Sky breaker sort that if the
wakanan royal family were to Simply give
it to somebody people would revolt and
so the ultimate statement of storm is I
can't have any sword but that but you
know where queen mother says you know
simply wait for black panther to return
right wait for the child to return plead
your case to him and he will be the one
to make the final decision until then
you are welcome to stay here as an
honored guest and storm of course
accepts now at that point we switch over
to her private quarters which looks like
it has an amazing view and then she of
course is met by shuri now this is
something that Marvel doesn't really
discuss too much and it kind of sucks
because seeing it Now is really cool
with storm being the wife of black
panther at one point in time the wife of
t'challa we never really got a lot of
exploration in terms of her relationship
with shuri it's one of these things
where the relationship between them is
that they're very much sisters right and
they're very close to each other they
have a lot of history there and it
wasn't necessarily history and so far as
Storm's involvement outside of black
panther it was something that she was
married to him and the two of them kind
of spent time together right when shuri
became the Black Panther in the
aftermath of of t'challa stepping down
prior to the events of Doom War storm
didn't really seem to have a lot of
involvement in shury's time as black
panther but that didn't necessarily take
away from from shuri's perception of her
a lot of that was really more because
shuri didn't want anybody else involved
right I mean even with black panther she
took his counsel lightly she wanted to
kind of prove herself rather she could
do it on her own that's kind of what she
was shooting for ultimately ended up
costing her her life but nonetheless
you know I guess better to go down into
that circumstance than any other but the
the important thing is they have this
kind of conversation and she again kind
of reiterates this position there are
people in wakanda who are literally just
looking for a reason to get rid of us
right every single day they're looking
for a reason to oust us because they
consider us to be too forward thinking
too Progressive that we're not real
really kind of latched down and allowing
ourselves to be held back by tradition
right we're not living in the past
essentially and so if we were to give
you this sword they would use that as a
reason to create revolt and not even my
mother the Queen Mother and not even
t'challa would be able to talk these
individuals down that a Revolt would
inevitably happen could we quash it yes
but it would cost lives in the process
but the ultimate result of this is they
end up hitting a stalemate that sure he
doesn't really side with storm and say
okay fine we'll find a way in for you
but storm doesn't really Ally with shuri
and say yeah you're right it really is
too much to ask I should be on my way
instead it's just kind of like you know
wait for t'challa to get here and
Storm's idea is I can't right I can't
wait for this and so she ends up of
course donning her X-Men uniform and
then taking to the skies in wakanda now
at this point we kind of get a little
bit of an explanation in terms of what
this whole deal is right and it sort of
bounces back and forth between what
Storm's doing at the moment and what's
happening now because you can obviously
tell what Storm's doing let's kind of
run over this history a little bit while
while you guys are are checking that out
but the idea is that the Temple of the
heart of wakanda is kind of like its
most revered place right it's this most
sacred place I don't recall if this runs
part and parcel with an acropolis but
the point is is that black panther
t'challa basically says the sword itself
is a symbol of the spirit of wakanda
right is what it means to be a wakandan
and it is never ever ever to be taken
from wakandan's soil right it's like
taking the heart of the country the
heart of the nation you just don't do it
right that if you take that it would be
like killing wakanda right more so than
that as as black panther takes her
through there is to tell her you know
tatara took her through there this of
course happened back during the days of
Civil War basically the Civil War event
at least we assume it does right because
that's when they got married that
t'challa says like if you're going to be
my wife it's important that you
understand the true history and culture
of wakanda but notice this one of the
things that t'challa does is he doesn't
tell her everything but what he says is
that here this facility is under
surveillance 24 Hours by priests and so
while Storm's able to use her power over
weather to create lightning that'll take
down power to the place and it takes
about 30 minutes for it to reboot that
there are still analog security here
right there's there's still guys there's
still people walking around Now
understand these guys know how to fight
they're able to kind of fight back right
they're they're they use they need more
than like well they're able to do more
than like use guns essentially that
these guys are trained as some of the
most prodigious fighters in all of Co
and I'm sorry in in the Marvel Universe
right on Earth or they're there to
protect the swordbreaker of what use
would they be if they were not highly
prodigious Fighters but as good good as
they are storm is better now this is
also partly because she's able to get
the upper hand and sneak up on them but
even with a knock down drag out fight
between the two storms able to overcome
and this comes from a variety of
different sources right it comes from
storms uh storms youth where she would
talk was taught how to fight during her
time as a thief it comes from Storm's
time on the X-Men when she was the wife
of Black Panther and was taught various
forms of martial arts by some of his
best fighters the Dora malashe these are
the kind of things that were where she
gained her experience from right so she
really is a highly prodigious Fighter
the problem with this is that once she
accesses this the acts as a skybreaker
with the intention of replacing it with
a with a fake sword that before she can
grab it the fake swords blown out of her
hand and the reason why is because sure
he's there and sure he suspected this is
exactly what storm would do that storm
would take this need and she would say I
cannot wait I cannot wait for t'challa
to get here or anything along those
lines now the fight between the two is
pretty intriguing and one of the things
to easily Overlook about shuri is how
good she is at fighting and she was
going to become the Black Panther she
had to first and foremost be the leader
of her armies right to be the commander
of all the the wakanan armies and nobody
none of the members of the wakanan army
would respect a black panther who
couldn't fight but the idea here is that
the two of them are able to fight pretty
closely now one thing to bear in mind is
that storm is not really looking to kill
shuri if she was she would just shut her
down entirely using her powers but again
because Sheree has been black panther
she's one of the best fighters in all of
wakanda and easily on par with storm and
so kind of going back and forth you end
up having shuri who manages to overtake
storm and then says like this is it I'm
gonna take you with me to the palace and
together we're going to speak with
t'challa right so notice this shuri's
response isn't I'm taking you back to
the palace and we're gonna throw you in
jail because you obviously try to steal
from us there's still respect there
there's still love and kindness there
why she's not seeing her as somebody who
betrayed wakanda even if it's true
because the the case of storm is so
extreme and sure he knows that storm
would not absolutely do this unless she
felt like she had no other choice right
that's what we're kind of looking at
here but storm ultimately ends up
overing power shuri and then replacing
the sword with a fake one and then
effectively leaving but as soon as she
does she's met by the arrival of
t'challa right t'challa immediately
shows up and says why are you doing this
right now t'challa shows up here with
his personal guard these guys are not to
be trifled with these guys and Adora
malashe all t'challa has to do is just
like give her the give the thumbs down
or just say take her and like they will
overpower her right like they will they
will they will over overpower her before
she can use her powers that's how good
these guys are they are wildly capable
now storm is super powerful she is Omega
Level but also keep in mind black
panther knows how to neutralize his wife
and this was anybody else storm would
overcome them and that would be the end
of it but being married to her and
knowing her as he does it would not take
long for black panther to take her down
right that's just kind of the way that
is and that's one of the things where he
says like why would you do this like I
would have done this like if you had
asked me I would have given you this
sword like my you know queen mother told
me everything that's going on if you
would ask I would have given you this
all you had to do was just wait and
that's where it really kind of breaks
down the relationship between the two
because ultimately they don't trust each
other and that's the biggest problem
that sure black panther trusts her
insofar as he would have given her this
but ultimately storm doesn't trust him
him right she doesn't trust that he
would have given her this weapon and
knowing you know in the whole time
knowing what discourse or what kind of
Discord it might cause among his people
she didn't trust him on that and
rightfully so right because black
panther has consistently made himself a
guy who would put his people first and
so it doesn't really make a whole lot of
sense that in the face of all that
consistently kind of maintaining that
position that he was suddenly change his
mind and not only change his mind give
her the most symbolic weapon of his
people right it doesn't really make a
whole lot of sense that he would
suddenly do that but ultimately he just
ends up letting her leave and the reason
why is because she says if I do not
leave here with this sword we are all
going to die right like understand I
would not do this unless I absolutely
have to you know me you were married to
me you know the kind of person that I am
the fact that I would come here and I
would defy the request of your mother to
wait until you return even if it only
would have been a couple hours for the
purpose of going in there and stealing
your most secret weapon and leaving you
have to know that it's a serious deal
and that's when he says let her go but
in response he says destroy the gate
right destroy the Coen gate like has
lost its ability to kind of sneak in and
out as they see fit right there was a
measure of trust that's been lost here
and so if Cook Collins If mutants are
going to come back here then they're
going to come back here through the
normal channels they're going to request
that we allow them in we will either
honor or deny that request and then
we'll meet them as we would any
ambassador from any other country
anywhere in the world storm you lost
that privilege no more special rights
for you right no more special privileges
for you and so storm ultimately ends up
making her way back to kirkoa she takes
her place on the on the the panel
alongside uh Magic and Wolverine and
that's where we are right and that
brings an end to this story
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are picking back up with the events of
Swords of X and in this video we are
covering the hellions so we initially
pick up here with the resurrection of
empath of Robert de la Rocha I think it
is I'm sorry Manuel de la Rocha I'm not
100 sure how to pronounce that name but
this guy empath is is not like the most
powerful but he's pretty powerful right
as his name suggests he can basically
read manipulate the the emotions of
other people he can also control
emotions but he can only do it one
emotion at a time right so he can make
you feel love or hate or anger or
something like that so he's a pretty
good asset to have on your team the
funny thing about this though is that
with the hellions team itself and this
is something to kind of of point out
here the thing about the hellions team
is these are kind of the cast offs to a
degree originally the hellions were the
team of Emma Frost it was almost like
Emma Frost's New Mutants team that kind
of went against the X-Men and New
Mutants and so on and so forth uh they
were on again off again enemies and
actually they teamed up on some of some
occasions but the overall idea here is
that they're largely led by Mr Sinister
and the way this kind of plays out is it
talks about what move is going to come
next right that the contest of Swords is
one where it may very well be the X-Men
will lose right or even if they win they
could lose some of their kind and it's
one of the most important things to
remember here that the X-Men are all
about maintaining their existing
population right like making sure they
don't lose mutant lives even if it does
involve some massive conflict that's
going on right and so the idea here is
to see if there's see if it's possible
to kind of find a way to basically win
without winning now this is kind of
Jonathan Hickman although he's not
really the one writing the story or at
least not directly but this is one of
those things where where I guess really
Zeb Wells is kind of taking a page out
of Jonathan Hickman but it's based on
the idea of of like Avengers New
Avengers if you guys recall when Valeria
was talking to Reed as she said you
can't win now it's time to find a way to
not lose that's basically what's kind of
going on here and Sinister is the one
who chimes in and says well what if we
sabotage them what if we let my hellions
do what they do best right lie cheat
steal until arako are like all their
swords their weapons belong to us right
and so the idea is that the hellions are
gonna go into other world and basically
either steal the sword words of the of
those individuals who are already there
or find some way to sabotage them now
this is hugely against the rules right
it's massively against the rules and if
they get caught there would be hell to
pay but the funny thing about this is
Xavier and Magneto kind of mull this
over for a second and say yeah but it
might be kind of worth it right like
it's worth the risk if we can save the
lives of mutants especially younger
mutants right if we can save the lives
of these individuals these people who
have to fight and not have to fight at
all and so the funny thing about this is
that initially The Stance of of people
like Exodus and a few people here and
there is we shouldn't do this but when
it's put to a vote five people vote in
favor of it which means it passes and so
from there the response of Exodus is
okay fine if that's going that's how
it's going to be the hellions will March
into a Rocco to end this tournament
before it starts and the fearless leader
Mr Sinister will lead the way and that's
when sinister's like wait a minute what
now now wait a minute now
I didn't say I was gonna go on this
mission right and it's kind of like no
but I mean they're your team you should
be the one to lead them so how many
people think the Sinister should lead
this campaign and only four people vote
right so Sinister you know it's not
really a passing motion Sinister is kind
of allowed to stay but then he kind of
gets back into everything going on right
he basically says like you know I want
havoc on my team uh I do not want him
hanging around with Polaris right we saw
how fast he just kind of gallivanted
into other world with her and he ended
up you know barely escaping by the skin
of his teeth I'm sorry Magneto but like
your daughter is bad news if Magneto's
like you know what I changed my vote I
vote for sinister to go and so it's like
Sinister now has to go
right Nathaniel Essex runs his mouth and
now he has to go on this Mission from
there we switch over directly to the
team itself and there are a couple
characters here that I want to kind of
talk about for a second orphan maker is
an interesting character in and of
himself right its name is is for the
most part Peter we don't really know a
ton about him and we don't even know a
whole lot about his powers we know that
like he can he has a kind of mechanized
suit but that's really it he's a
character that hasn't really been fully
fleshed out over the years the funny
thing about this is that it is one of
these instances where it's kind of a
shame right like orphanmaker appeared
back in 1988 and aside from him having
kind of been like a cohort of Nanny and
you know her basically saving him for
being killed by by Sinister because
Sinister couldn't control him he's
fought the he thought the the x-rays
font X Factor I think he fought the
Avengers at one point Marvel just never
really did anything with him so the fact
that he's here I think is kind of a
reflection of his status and the overall
X-Men comics and he's almost kind of
like an unsellable character nanny has a
far more significant history even if
it's only on a small scale probably one
of Nanny's biggest moments came when she
de-aged storm when she turned storm into
a little girl and that's when storm
first met Gambit right so it was kind of
during Chris claremont's era but then of
course you guys know psylock you guys
also are aware of Havoc the character of
wild child is a little more
um I would say obscure to the average
comic book reader Wild Child appeared
back in 1983 I think it was um and he
was a character who well he originally
appeared in Alpha flight but he was a
character named Kyle Gibney who was
based largely off Wolverine and
Sabertooth and it was part of that era
whereby you know because Wolverine and
Sabertooth were so popular that Marvel
was kind of finding ways to basically
create characters that would make them
intriguing uh with John Byrne writing
the title right it was kind of like
let's create like a wolverine type
character and even within like his
origin story it's still very similar
right so very similar to wolverines in
the sense that Kyle Gibney was basically
a kid whose Powers manifested he was
essentially kicked out of the home by
his parents he wanted the street he was
ultimately taken in by gamma flight he
ended up being taken in and experimented
on by the original secret Empire kind of
an offshoot of Hydra he eventually
became like weapon Omega and then you
know there was the whole of a new X
Factor and so on but he's one of these
characters where you don't really I mean
if you read the old Comics wild child
had a pretty interesting run especially
in the early 1990s when it was like
super high octane fast-paced stories um
in 2009 or I think it was 2006 2009 he
died during the Wolverines origin story
arc and then basically brought back as
part of kirkoa but from there you also
have gray Crow and gray Crow is a
long-standing character because he was
originally part of the original
Marauders right they were led by
Nathaniel Essex during the mutant
Massacre he has the ability to basically
tap into technology so it's kind of a
hodgepodge ragtag gang here right I mean
these this is not by any means kind of
an organized team I mean it is but it's
it's just kind of characters who were
there that nobody could really do
anything with or couldn't really control
or whose appearance is whose Powers made
them you know unable to kind of function
in the normal world but the idea behind
this is that Sinister initially brought
back a version of himself and then it
essentially kind of thought him out with
the intention of sending that version of
himself out on a mission instead of of
sinister uh Prime so to speak going
himself and then this version that he
thought out actually Rebels and he's
like no I don't want to go so they
actually kind of end up invoking a game
of rock paper scissors in order to
decide who it is that's gonna go out
there and it turns out that the main
Sinister was the one who lost so he has
to go on this Mission now once they
enter into uh into what's basically
Avalon this led by Jamie Braddock if you
guys recall our video on Excalibur that
that story arc that we did this guy is
powerful he's a reality warper he's also
kind of crazy and he's basically ranting
and raving at this guy muford uh who
supposedly had told Jamie that he knows
that he's familiar with horses and that
uh he's an equestrian and that they kind
of brought this horse in for the purpose
of of you know training it breaking it
into the Jimmy Bradley could enjoy it it
turns out muford never said any such
thing but me for never you know claims
he never said that but you kind to have
Sinister and Jimmy Braddock sort of
hanging out right you're kind of kind of
talking to each other but this is
something that's kind of interesting to
me because it's a little bit of humor
and what's otherwise a pretty
interesting story arc right and I I kind
of love this to be honest it's one of
the good things about extra swords and
acts of Swords does a really good job of
maintaining the tone of the existing
Comics while also giving us an ongoing
story and I I kind of have to say I
think that's something that Marvel's
been lacking in recent years right that
you have a tone of a particular comic
book and then it goes into an event and
the tone of the comic becomes the tone
of the event and as soon as that event
is over the tone of the Comet goes back
to normal again and is kind of jarring
and so what you end up getting here is
is initially Jimmy Braddock who kind of
shoots down the idea and saying like hey
no I really don't want to have anything
to do with with basically sneaking into
other world and essentially betraying
the rules of Saturday and laid down
that's not supposed to happen and so
where Sinister is like look you know I
if if we can if we can pull this off
like we can basically help you kind of
preserve your fun right you know
preserving your fun is what we're
shooting for and that's when Jamie's
like hey muford uh take the horse and
get the horse out of here if you can you
know or you because supposedly you're
good at horses or that's what you claim
and meford's like I never said that man
I never said I was good with horses
right and so I was like dude I'm getting
like Jimmy Brad's like dude I'm getting
tired of hearing that just take the
horse and get out of here the whole time
you first is trying to like pull on this
horse and then Jamie Braddock in the
midst of a conversation with Sinister
you know where Sinister kind of
references the fact that this place is
kind of unsafe under the rule of Jimmy
bratta Jamie's like oh man he's like
someone's been talking about attorney
he's like mewford I just remembered it
was I who was raised around horses not
you you nitwit and there's this guy
it's this kind of goofiness right this
kind of goofiness and nonsense that
comes with the character of Jamie
Braddock and it's awesome like I love
that kind of nonsensical nature of him
because as goofy as he is he's also
incredibly powerful right I mean the
guy's able to work reality potentially
on a universal scale he's just that
capable and so it's one of these things
where the response of Jaime is okay fine
then I will do that and and I offer you
like my prized horse right I'll offer
you silk Mane what are you gonna give me
in return as part of this deal that
we've struck this is part of this
bargain instead of just like we're not
gonna give you anything I don't want
your horse and that's when when he's
like he's like a horse is like a huge
amount of responsibility and and it's
kind of funny because Jimmy stands up
and he was like everybody listen you
know the words of sinister have touched
me the idea of responsibility
responsibility is a very important thing
and I just remember that I have the
responsibility to report any suspicious
involvement any suspicious actions or
suspicions uh suspicious travelers to
saturnin so if I'm going to maintain
responsibility it's important that I
tell her about what it is that you're
doing and so ultimately you end up
having Sinister being like Okay We're
Not Gonna We're Not Gonna Take the horse
but I can give you something else in
step and so Sinister loses his cape
now here's the thing on this surface as
an old school as a long time comic book
reader there's a part of me that's kind
of like Sinister would never act this
way right a Sinister is super hardcore
but there's another part of me that's
kind of like I dig this I like the
nonsensical Sinister right the one who's
just like I don't really take things
seriously anymore I just kind of goof
off you know I'm sort of just kind of a
of a goofy guy I kind of enjoy that
version of sinister because I've been
reading the old school version of
sinister for so long it's pretty fun and
so once they actually make their way
here right they've kind of past that you
know supposed kind of interim station
right kind of a Way Station of sorts uh
with Jimmy Braddock and they actually
arrive into really kind of other world
itself they're immediately met by what's
essentially an Envoy of saturnin who
basically charges them right and so it's
like you guys have to stop right you
guys are in possession of silk Mane uh
you guys basically have this horse that
belong to saturnin herself the fact that
you you have this horse means you stole
it because we know the horse has been
stolen some crazy naked guy just ran up
on the property and took it so like we
know Jimmy Braddock and his nakedness
just running onto the to the territory
of saturnian and stealing a horse Buck
Naked which is sound like the most Jamie
Braddock thing that a person could do I
I feel like somebody like people are
kind of skip into this video and
somebody's gonna land on this part and
just be like what like that's
the response here but it's kind of like
okay like empath we need your powers
manipulate their emotions and turn them
into allies and he's like no I'm good
he's like I hate all of you guys I hate
everybody here I hope you die and I hope
that I hope
I that if you guys coming back because
when you whenever you die in other world
there's no guarantee you'll come back
the way that you were so it's like when
you guys come back you come back in such
a screwed up state that like the
entirety of kirkoa will cheer when I
when I suffocate you when I spare you of
your miserable existence like I hope
that's the way things are right like I
don't I hate you guys and so in response
like sinister's like surely there's
something that you want right some kind
of a favor I'll give you anything you
want and he's like I want Greg Crow as
my pet Greg Crow flips right he's just
like not a chance I'm gonna cut you in
half right and so senator's like okay
dude that's fine like like just whatever
you know and so he uses his powers great
Crow becomes just totally enamored with
empath he's like man your eyes those
sparkling eyes right you're just a
radiant Soul right so he absolutely
adores empath empath in turn uses his
powers on the envoy of saturnin and they
basically give Sinister and his crew
whatever it is that they need and just
kind of go forward from there and it's
kind of a crazy thing to see this story
where where Greg Crow is just kind of
frolicking through the grass and talking
about how great empath is it's one of
these things where you kind of have to
go and read the old mutant Massacre and
see how like you know sadistic his
character was in order to really get a
grasp for how funny this is old school
comic book fans would probably get a
kick out of it right like the new guys
are kind of like
it's it's a thing you know it's
what kind of agree is you're making with
making their way through here they all
kind of agree this is gonna go pretty
bad right like they're all kind of like
this is gonna be a this is like a
suicide mission basically right so it's
almost kind of like the hellions have
become Marvel Suicide Squad it's kind of
wild but it's like we're probably gonna
die and if we don't die we're definitely
not gonna succeed things are gonna go
pretty terrible for us right so they're
definitely off to a great start
okay so we are picking up with the New
Mutants as part of Swords of X part six
and this one is totally different from
the video that we did with the hellions
right the hellions was a lot more
comedic more of a dark humor actually
this is part seven I think if we take
into account
um X of Swords creation right it's kind
of what that is nonetheless um this
one's pretty dark right not not really
dark this one's a just a different kind
of tone but um this this one really
picks up uh with it being written by Ed
brison of course you know it's going to
be amazing but this one picks up with
magic iliano Rasputin basically hitting
up like Cyclops and cable and kind of
telling him like cable you gotta grab
your sword you got to come here we got a
great big huge thing going on uh you
gotta bring your sword right you know
it's part of the whole swords of X event
basically come here stand on your altar
and get ready for the whole great bq's
thing not a whole lot going there the
really big moment kind of comes with
regards to Warlock and uh and Doug
Ramsay now Doug Ramsey most of you guys
are familiar with just because of our
coverage of dawn of X right he's the guy
that can basically understand any
language and he's the one that
translates for krakowa itself whenever
krakowa wants to speak to the to the
quiet Council or uh when the quiet
Castle has a question for cocoa or
something along those lines but warlock
is a more interesting character right so
warlock appeared back in 1984 and he was
created by Chris Claremont and Bill
sinkewicks right and the whole idea
behind warlock is that he comes from a
planet that's never really identified
but the idea of the planet is that it's
basically kind of a living techno
organism right like the people the the
denizens it's native citizens are like
living technology and the way this works
is that when parents give birth to their
kids the kids basically prove their
ability to live by fighting their
parents to the death and if the kid
kills their parents the kid continues on
they have their own offspring and the
cycle continues but for the case of
warlock he actually rebelled against
this ideology right he didn't he didn't
really believe in fighting against
anybody and so with his father basically
being the ruler of their world he
essentially fled and of course is this
you know led to a great big huge Chase
and he eventually landed on Earth and
then ended up encountering the X-Men and
more or less became part of Xavier's
team uh or at least the New Mutants for
quite some time right so that's kind of
the longest word explanation of him much
like hellions I feel like we should do a
video on him in the same way that we
should do a video on wild child but the
idea here is that warlock has basically
been a long time friend of the X-Men
right and that's why warlock refers to
himself as self he refers to dog as like
Doug friend right it's like a computer
talking to to people he's also a little
janky if you guys remember him on like
X-Men the Animated Series he was he was
a little you know a little janky you
know a little a little weird but the
idea is that Doug is is essentially part
of the people who are supposed to fight
here on Cocoa but the problem is that
he's not really a fighter but he's a
translator but he wants to be a fighter
right he wants to be something more than
the guy who just translates things and
that's kind of the crazy thing is that
Doug's weapon is supposed to be warlock
right that's that's kind of what his
weapon is supposed to be and and warlock
basically says like oh I can turn myself
into a sword and we can fight together
you know but it's kind of crazy because
initially he kind of says you know why
should you use his sword and like start
hacking down trees and stuff and and
cocoa is like no you don't either right
and that's when Ileana Rasputin appears
and Ileana Rasputin kind of takes Doug
under her wing and starts training him
on how to fight the problem with this is
that Doug is not a fighter he's never
really been a fighter that was never
really his thing he's like Sage right
he's almost kind of like the brains
behind the operation and that's one of
the biggest issues that he runs into is
that in his little bit of a kind of bout
with Ileana Rasputin he's taken down
quick fast and in a hurry right he's
taken down so quickly and the response
of Ileana is you're you're supposed to
be one of the 10 Champions fighting for
earth and the issue is that if you die
out there there's no guarantee you're
gonna come back the way you are the
reality is you just need to stay here
right like you just you just need to
stay here and it's one of these things
where you kind of switch over to the
quiet Council and you have this kind of
discussion taking place between krakowa
and and Doug and of course you know
basically Graco is talking in a language
that nobody but Doug can really
understand and it's a little bit of
bickering going on as a quiet counsel is
you know having their discussions or
what have you or seemingly a Sinister is
getting ready to go on his mission right
going on his mission with the hellions
but the whole gist here is that uh you
know the the mission of sinister is kind
of questionable and that's when when
Doug kind of asked the question like
what happens if sinister's Mission fails
and the idea is well I mean you know
we'll explore that option when we get to
it but for right now there's no real
point in in really focusing on anything
else right like we'll focus on those
things you know you just worry about
being our translator it's one of these
things where where even Krakow himself
is on board with the idea that Doug
doesn't go right that Doug is basically
the person who represents the voice of
of kirkoa on the quiet Council Soca Cola
can be heard he's kind of necessary in
that way but with Doug himself he's like
you know the Rule's been set I was
chosen to be part of the ten I want to
fight and the idea here is that they're
kind of looking at a looking at a at the
possibility of replacing Doug with
somebody else sneaking somebody else in
to take Doug's place instead of Doug
actually being the one to fight now
whether or not that can be done we don't
know and we have to believe based on the
prophecy that there's a reason why Doug
was chosen maybe there was no reason why
maybe it was just arbitrary there's just
luck of the draw this is Doug he's gonna
be the one to fight and he's gonna be
the one to die right like we don't
really know the kind of continuing his
training sessions with uh with magic she
continues to get the upper hand on him
and the reason why is because Doug's not
using his powers the way he needs to
that with Ileana being so hard on him
that kakala initially kind of comes to
the the rescue but Doug says no let her
go and this is one of these things where
it's like Ileana is doing her best to
just try to keep him alive by by
teaching him to Be an Effective fighter
Chris Ileana had to learn the hard way
when she was a little girl she was taken
to limbo she learned you know the Black
Arts and all that kind of stuff she
learned how to fight she had to learn to
survive and that's really what Doug has
to learn here he has to learn how to
survive because the truth about this is
that with Doug being so important on
krakowa in a lot of ways he's been Molly
coddled by the X-Men right like they
take care of him they make sure that
he's kind of prized above almost all
others because his job is to just kind
of you know be an interpreter but he
doesn't want to be resigned to that kind
of a situation right and plus it's a
boring life you know and that's when
Ileana kind of chimes in and says
understand the stakes here Doug like
this is not a small thing when Doug's
like I wasn't you know I really wasn't
doing that bad she's like no you don't
understand what this is right like these
are apocalypse's children and they they
literally crushed him without breaking a
sweat they kill is something that we as
the X-Men have almost never been able to
do wait we've almost never been able to
kill uh apocalypse we've never been able
to do that right all we've ever been
able to do is find him off they were
able to punch a hole in him right they
were able to injure him in a way that
we've just never been able to do those
are the forces that we're fighting up
against and you are fumbling and
bumbling right you don't know what
you're doing so yeah I mean I guess in
the grand scheme of things you didn't
really do that bad but the reality is
you did terrible but in comparison to
the people who are fighting out there
and that's true right because you look
at Ileana Rasputin she's a hardcore died
in the wolf fighter you look at storm
it's the same way Wolverine it's the
exact same way then you have Cipher
right this guy understands languages and
it's one of these things where he kind
of kind of Muses to himself and says you
know kind of gets irritated Ileana right
because she doesn't seem to believe that
he understands the stakes but he says
like I'm putting my life on the line to
save others right like that matters
doesn't it and that's when Exodus pops
up and says it does matter but
understand no one's going to sing songs
about your life no one's going to tell
stories about it because it won't be
worth telling your skill is language not
battle right that's what you're here for
you're here to you're here to interpret
language you're not here as a fighter
why you were chosen is anyone body's
guess but it's obvious to the quiet
Council it's obvious to Iliana Rasputin
and it's obvious to you you're not a
fighter you're not here to fight and
it's one of these things where Exodus
says maybe there's some kind of a
loophole right maybe there's something
that we can do if sinister's plan fails
you know when his plan fails maybe
there's something we can do where we can
switch you out with somebody else right
if the if if benedu Perry was given the
given the sword right if if Exodus was
the one who was going to fight he would
probably win right and he would probably
do better than anybody else right keep
in mind Exodus is an Omega Level
telepath this guy is hugely powerful I
mean the world shakes with the kind of
power this guy possesses right it's just
it's kind of nuts but at the end of the
day the stance is Doug was chosen Doug
has to be the one to fight right Doug
has to be the one to engage in this
conflict and so when he's back in his
quotas he's met by really Mondo kind of
taken over by kirkoa and gracoa tries to
reiterate it again right like there must
be a way to send somebody else in your
place the whole world's against him but
like the whole world is against Doug No
One Believes he can succeed and the
reality of this is that can be
disheartening but there's also something
just great about standing in the face of
everyone who told you that you couldn't
and then you do right there's just
something about proving them all wrong
and even if they don't admit it knowing
that they know they have egg on their
face knowing that they know that they
were foolish to question you they were
foolish to tell you that it couldn't be
done and that's what's so cool about
that because that's the relatable thing
right like with Thomas explained I ran
into that right I ran into people who
told me you can't do that right you
can't be a full-time YouTuber there's no
way you could succeed in that and look
where I am now right and they're they're
stuck with egg on their face looking
like buffoons they were foolish enough
to question me and there's a great kind
of empowerment that comes with that and
I would say this really kind of proves
to be the turning point of Doug Ramsey
because he just kind of breaks and he's
like I've had enough right I can't run I
can't hide this is the responsibility
that's been bestowed on me I'm scared
out of my wits right like you have to
understand I'm terrified I know that I
might not come back I know that I may
die out there and if they resurrect me I
won't come back as a person that I was
before I'll lose all my powers or I'll
come back twisted and evil who y'all I
have no real idea but understand this is
my responsibility and that's usually
what it takes right it takes this idea
of of people having a thing that they
want to achieve and being met with
adversity and every conceivable way
right sometimes this adversity is in
your own head right it's your fear it's
your anxiety it's your nerves it's your
depression it's any number of things
that are constantly just bumping up
against you and telling you it can't be
done there's no way it can be done if
you could have done it you would have
done it by now right like all these all
this negativity that feeds into you and
then when it comes from the outside
people who are telling you you're making
every mistake you're not doing this
you're not doing that you're screwing up
then it all kind of it's like boiling
over and then something just snaps and
it just turns into I can't and then it's
it's just a matter of I don't care what
anybody else has to say the voices get
silent and it's just this pure
determination that's what you're left
with the desire not to prove to them but
to prove to yourself that you can
actually do it and that's what happens
right Doug goes into his training
session with with Ileana Rasputin and he
by no means comes out as like a
world-class sword but he starts using
his power he's countering every move
she's making he's making All the Right
Moves and he's saying because I look at
you Ileana Rasputin and your moves are a
language I understand what you're going
to do I can predict what you're going to
do before you do it I can read you the
way you move how you fight your style
it's no different than understanding
French or English or Spanish it's just
in this instance I'm understanding
swordsmanship I'm learning the language
of fencing and because he's able to pick
up on it so fast his skill starts to
increase at an almost exponential rate
and one of the first things he picks up
on with Ileana is you're letting me win
you're holding me back why are you doing
this why are you holding back like this
and she says you know you have the
potential to use your powers to overcome
anybody that you fight because you're
you're like Taskmaster right like you
will learn to fight like them and you'll
learn to understand how they fight as
you fight right you'll be able to
overcome them and so as that time you
know when that progresses one thing that
that I'm afraid of and one thing that
concerns me and believe me when I tell
you this that if you raise your sword to
fight anybody on other world it'll be
the last thing that you do that there's
nothing you can do to stop it in essence
that while he is making progress and he
is getting better he's still
ill-equipped to face off against the
forces that are out there to face off
against those various threats so again
still a little bit of opposition there
but if I'm being if I'm a betting man if
I'm being honest with you guys which I
feel like as often as I say that I'm a
betting man ah then I would say this
will come down to Doug Ramsay like it'll
come down to Cipher it'll come down to
him basically being the one who will
most likely come out on top and save the
day if he doesn't think Graco is kind of
screwed but at the moment we are four
Swords captured five if we include cable
we've got four or five more to go
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are picking back up again
with swords of X in this instance we
kind of join with cable however you pick
up with cables Cyclops and Jean Gray
while they are on board What's called
the peak which is the main operating
base of Sword so a little bit of History
here when it comes to Marvel Comics
because I feel like it's important to
explain the nature of Sword because
we're going to see them in the MCU so
sword stands for the sentient World
observation and response department and
this was not a thing that existed until
astonishing X-Men by Joss Whedon the
whole idea behind this is that in Marvel
Comics you have shield and shield has
been around for a long long time the
name for shield the acronym has changed
over the years but the idea is that
Shield was designed to monitor threats
to earth right to basically monitor
Earth itself but where Shield monitored
Earth sword monitored space and sword
would look out for like Galactus coming
to Earth or like the the Scrolls who
were looking to launch an attack on
Earth or the the cree or something like
that and they would warn the superheroes
accordingly or if they had the power to
handle it on their own they would take
care of them ourselves now the leader of
Sword was a woman named Abigail brand
and Abigail brand had the ability to
understand and speak any language in
existence right now she was the leader
for a long time from 2004 when
astonishing X-Men first came out running
all the way up until all new all
different Marvel and when that kicked
off that's when you had uh Carol Danvers
who took over as director of sword and
then sword was renamed to the alpha
flight program and so it's kind of been
that way ever since now what involvement
Carol Danvers has in sword or the new
Alpha flight I'm not really even sure in
this day and age I haven't read her
comics for two years so I have no clue
what's going on in the Carol Danvers
line of comics but the whole idea here
is that that sword has more or less kind
of been shut down now this ties into
cable and Jean Gray and and cyclops by
way the fact that that Cable's sword is
one of the 10 swords they need for the
swords of X event right for the 10
swords challenge but he had plugged it
in to the end of the peak in order to
power it back up to kind of find out
what's been going on here and as they're
going through and as they're
investigating of course magic chimes in
as we saw in a previous video where she
told cable hey like we need you back
here right like you need to come back
here you know we need your sword the
light of galador all that kind stuff now
a funny thing about the sword of of
cable the light of galador is this is
one of those instances when what's going
on in the X-Men Universe because it's
being led by Jonathan Hickman ties back
into the work that Jonathan Hickman
already did and it's one of the reasons
why I'm glad that we did Avengers and
New Avengers because if you recall in
that story when we were kind of leading
up to the events of infinity we had the
builders and the builders had literally
appeared in the main Marvel Universe and
were making their way towards Earth with
the intention of destroying it but the
idea is that along their way to earth
when they entered into the main Marvel
Universe they ended up annihilating all
life on the planet galador and galador
is a world that belongs to a group
called The Space Knights and space
Knights are quite literally just like a
peacekeeping force of individuals who
have undergone a procedure that converts
them from Strictly you know whatever
their organic nature was to becoming a
kind of machine with a human mind their
Essences and their Consciousness are
backed up into those uh robots and then
they kind of go forward accordingly but
the idea was that at some point with the
Reformation of the Multiverse it was
kind of a reference to the to the the
events leading up to the collapse of the
multiversity the builders and when cable
got his hands on the sword on the light
of galador it led to a great big huge
battle with a whole bunch of galadorian
space Knights the fact that cable still
has the sword kind of tells you how that
battle ended up going down because I'm
trying to find I like the idea of what
we did with Avengers and New Avengers
where we had like the comics that we
were normally covering and then as like
a background series we just had like an
enormous series taking place and I'm
kind of debating on what I want to do
next if I want to do something like
uncanny uncanny Avengers if I want to do
something like like Rick reminders
Avengers run or X-Men run or was it
Uncanny X-Force that he did if we do
something like we continue Green Lantern
I'm kind of figuring out what it is that
I want to do right so make sure you guys
leave some comments down below and give
me some ideas but uh that's kind of how
we are with regards to Cable having this
sword but the cool thing about this is
is again Magic's like hey you got to
come back here right like you got to
come back to earth uh and you have to
basically you know give us your sword or
at least stand here with your swords you
can be part of the circle kibble's
response is I'll be back here in a
little bit we gotta check out what's
going on here now the funny thing about
this is that with the station being
powered down this never really happens
we never really see instances where
sword is not operating inside of its
base of operations the fact that there's
seemingly nobody there indicates that
something really bad happened here
that's really kind of what's going on
and so what you end up getting is this
kind of realization that there's this
bulkhead that's sealed shut and that it
had been done in a hurry right like
somebody had wielded it super fast and
so the only time you do that is when
you're trying to keep something out and
so of course the X-Men open it like why
not and so once they open the door they
end up calling for Jean Gray right now
Jean Gray and of course Cyclops and and
cable had kind of split and so what she
ends up doing is is going you know kind
of discovering this making this little
discovery of herself she finds one
person inside this whole space station
right just kind of sitting on the bridge
and when she gets in there this person
kind of says like like ask her a few
questions like you turn the power back
on like you you basically powered the
station back on why would you do that
the indication here is that initially
there was just kind of like a sound
right they heard these different sounds
basically the sounds of people dying
right it was kind of like a rhythm but
you would hear people dying then you
would hear silence and you would hear
people dying and then you would hear
silence and it was just it was it was
repeating and then they ended up
realizing it was a sound they were
Hearing in the their head that it was
just kind of going through their heads
over and over and over again and that
half the station was wiped out before
they could even regroup or understand
what was really going on and so what you
end up finding out is that those
individuals who weren't wiped out were
seemingly taken over by some kind of a
force right and this guy has been taken
over by part of that force and so what
you end up having is Jean Gray who tries
to read his mind and figure out what's
going on and she can't she's basically
met by this kind of of blocking right in
the sense that whatever this is I took
over this guy the first thing they did
was fortify their minds against
telepathy and so what this shows is a
handful of different things one it shows
intelligence rational thinking and two
it shows the ability to overcome Powers
right you cannot overcome a power that
you're not familiar with and so because
of that it means they're familiar with
telepathy right if you didn't know what
telepathy was how would you know how to
overcome that power because of that Jean
Gray kind of experiences this sort of
psychic backlash to a degree and this
guy basically says like you know we
pledged our lives to defend this world
and nobody ever came for us and so what
it indicates is they sent out an SOS
this guy Yanks the airlock and ends up
sucking himself out so I guess he's on
an airlock and not the bridge right
right but like he ends up sucking
himself out into space and the guy dies
and so when Jean Gray hits him up and
says are you guys still in the science
lab right hits up Cyclops so are you
guys still in the science lab the
response is yes and she's like do not
open anything like do not open any doors
don't do anything like I'm getting over
there as fast as I can whatever it is
that's on this thing killed everybody on
the space station and the response of
Cyclops is we know and that's when cable
asks this interesting question did
saturni know we'd find this and that it
would probably try to kill us right is
she hoping that it would try to kill us
no the thing about this is that Jean
Gray got a little bit of a kind of
Glimpse here in terms of what was going
on and what she says is that this this
space station was infiltrated by
something called the viscora right kind
of like a faceless death right is what
what is kind of referred to here it's a
little bit ambiguous but you do see a
couple of them come out and then you end
up seeing you know the X-Men basically
attacked them and essentially destroy
them right which means they can be they
can be killed but they kind of say these
things like Cleanse This reality is
already fetid right like we're going to
cleanse this whole reality and seemingly
move on to the next one and so it kind
of gives premise to the idea that
they're multi-dimensional or
multi-universal forces right so like
they go from one universal space to the
next doing whatever it is that they do
but the important thing is that Jean
Gray actually kind of kind of uses
astral projection and her Essence more
or less leaves her body and travels
through this portal and into the other
side and that's when you end up seeing
that there is essentially just this
massive portal more or less where the
source from which they're all emanating
from and pouring in right and that and
the responsive Gene is kill everybody
that you see right like kill every
single one you can possibly find and so
it's one of these things where like the
whole station kind of lurches right
cables sent on this mission is sit on
this task to go and grab his sword and
to pull it up pull it out of the core
and basically de-power the ship which
would shut the portal back down again
and of course he successfully does right
everything's kind of shut back down and
then it's like okay like what do we do
here what this does is it kind of picks
up with one of those little interim
Pages they give us where they kind of
fill in the gaps by kind of giving us um
some kind of went over the crazy thing
about this is that in the span of 10
minutes right in the span of 10 minutes
an anomaly is detected in science lab 14
that personal transponders of the entire
science division are terminated so they
don't know their stasis they don't know
if they're living if they're dead or any
of that stuff but and so in response to
that hostile boarding throughout voting
Protocols are initiated fire teams are
just are deployed on search and rescue
missions right so they're searching lab
14 and that Associated part of the ship
to find out what's going on and so from
there fire team deployment shifted to
recovery and then they manually attempt
to depressurize lab 14 which is
basically prevented by a sales safe they
try to they they try to like cut it off
from the ship right they try to open an
airlock and suck out whatever's in there
right so whatever's in there is
literally wreaking havoc from there
you're seven minutes in to like this
initial indication that something's
wrong and it's a mass casualty event 32
percent of the peak crew has been
terminated in a non-decompression event
that began in lab 14 basically saying
some kind of an anomaly was detected
this portal something came through the
portal uh and basically started
attacking them from there you go into
safety Protocols are overridden by
station Command right so the indication
is that whatever this is has been taking
over people managed to make its way to
the Command Deck and then in turn is
basically making it possible for this to
spread and then you go into General
quarters right which is is anybody who's
kind of out there and not working at the
moment and 55 of them are all killed
tactical approval for fire team
deployment through the incursion gate so
basically we're gonna go to the other
side and find out what's going on uh and
then it's power draining from core to
lab 14 which is there's something in
there that's basically powering itself
up then you go into Power unstable comms
array life support and orbital systems
are all compromised this ship is
effectively shutting down right because
the core is being depowered then you get
into 78 of peak crew has been terminated
and then Siege of lab 14 was totally
unsuccessful Command Mission to
dismantle Power Station successful power
level is reduced completely and totally
right so basically they shut the whole
thing down in the span of 10 minutes
they detected some kind of an anomaly
this anomaly took out everybody in the
science lab it's spread like wildfire it
basically took over other individuals
which ensured its progression throughout
the ship it started wiping out as many
people as it possibly could to the point
that 78 of the entire crew was killed
and then they ended up having to shut
the ship down in order to get this thing
under control now in terms of what this
was and and how all this worked the only
thing we really know here here is it
some kind of a virus right some kind of
like a living virus and that's it we
don't get anything else besides that
instead you have cable who comes through
the comes through the portal from you
know into krakowa with the light of
galador and then says okay and takes a
stance on the on the the actual on his
little icon right on his little thing
here and that's it right now from there
you have uh Cyclops and you have Gene
who make their way out and you have uh
Magic who's basically engaging in
essentially a telepathic conversation
with them now the funny thing about this
is we're not given a clear on
understanding of what they're talking
about the indication here is that they
plan on running some kind of busy
backdoor you know event like some kind
of backdoor or backdoor campaign or
something like that right like you kind
of have this conversation that comes out
you got Jean Gray and cyclops you're
like is it just me or does it look like
it's going to rain the response of magic
is it feels like it's going to come down
like daggers you're like do you have a
plan the response to Cyclops is you know
I've been noodling on some things two
main problems communication and
transportation and it's like well we
have some suggestions for rides but
communication is not my strong suit and
then Gene turn says Otherworld is locked
down telepathically but I think we could
punch our way through if we had enough
of us working on it can it be done the
responsive Gene is it has to be done
something's going on here like we're not
fully aware of what it is but
something's taking place here right and
the response of magic is okay if you
guys need me to I can keep an eye on
cable make sure that he does what he's
supposed to do that he's none the wiser
of what's happening the the indication
here and we're not we're not giving it's
not really on the nose but the
indication here is that whatever was on
that ship seemingly took over Cyclops
and Gene I'm not going to swear to that
and I could be entirely wrong it could
have to do with the plan that we've seen
unfolding right kakoa kind of
implementing its own plan with regards
to how to steal the swords from the from
the enemy side and it's a multi-faceted
plan right it's not just the Marauders
who are doing it it's Cyclops and Gene
launching their own plan probably other
direction of Charles Xavier we're not
entirely sure that's one of the things
about this is with us being 22 Parts
we're only in like part 10 right now
right so we're not even halfway through
uh or really I think it's more like part
eight right now right so we're not even
close to halfway through and we're still
in that section where we get more
questions than we do answers but
regardless it's cool like I dig this I
think this was going to be one of those
stories like so many Jonathan Hickman
stories where it kind of reads better in
trade right like when you have the whole
thing collected and you can go you can
read it all in one go but of course
we'll find out by the time we get to the
end
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are continuing our dawn of X
coverage yes we are and in this video we
are picking up with Excalibur here's the
cool thing about this right here's the
cool thing about this this is really
going to kind of allow us a chance to
offer some pretty cool explanations
insofar as how I've the captain written
core Works Jonathan Hickman's Avengers
and New Avengers the collapse of the
Multiverse how all that stuff ties into
what's going on right now with his X-Men
run this is why I always tell people if
you want to read Jonathan Hickman's work
read it by itself do not read anything
else unless you absolutely have to this
is an example of where you kind of have
to right because other people are
writing the swords of X story as opposed
to just Jonathan Hickman and it all
basically ties together but you can
literally just read Hickman by himself
and read nothing else and just maybe
catch up on a couple things here and
there but the cool thing here is it
offers it allows us a bit of an
explanation but before we get to that
point we pick up with the arrival of
Jamie Braddock and Brian Braddock as
they've been summoned by saturnine and
the whole idea is that as they're
meeting uh Betsy Braddock here right as
we're meeting you know Captain Britton
here once they arrive things get pretty
murky pretty fast and the reason why is
because as Brian Braddock shows up here
Betsy realizes he's in possession of the
sword of Might and when she asks why is
that here his response is because I
brought it for you and the idea of Brian
Braddock is to basically switch these
things right for Brian to retake the
amulet and for for Betty for Betsy to
take the sword of Might now here's a
reason why that matters because once all
that passes and they're basically met by
the arrival of saturnin that she's
assembled them here and it looks like
it's basically a kind of giant get
together to honor the Fallen Captain
written core that existed before the
events of Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers but the idea is that this kind
of argument is taking place in such a
way to where Brian wants things to go
back to the way they were before that
one of the things that Saturday talks
about is the fall of the Captain Britain
court now the way this worked was the
result of Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers right so the Captain Britain
core in previous years was largely
created by Merlin and then Roma in a
combination of both and the way this
would play out is that in any one
Universe on any one Earth out there that
what you would have if some individual
who would be met at some point in time
by Merlin or Roma or both and what they
would do is they would present them with
an option they would say you have the
choice of the sword of might or the
Amulet of right there wasn't really a
wrong answer there but whichever one
they took they would go forward with
those corresponding powers and they
would in effect become the Captain
Britain of their universe and the idea
is that the Captain Britain of that
Universe which served to protect that
universe but also serve as part of a
larger whole they would protect the
Multiverse alongside other Captain
written members and so think of it as a
more localized version of like I'm sorry
a much larger version of the Green
Lantern Corps and so the result of this
is that during Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers as we covered
with that story that there came a point
where saturnin and the omniversal
development Court were trying to
understand why the Multiverse was
collapsing why they didn't fully
understand it and so what they ended up
doing was getting their hands on a map
maker with a desire to effectively crack
the map maker understand its code and
then get a get a bigger picture the
problem with this was that the map maker
ended up summoning its own forces right
and it really was more of a sedera
Madhuri so as opposed to a map maker but
they ended up summoning the forces of
both the ivory Kings and the ivory King
soldiers and this led to the complete
and total annihilation of the Captain
Britain Corps the only person who
survived was Brian Braddock and Brian
Braddock only survived because saturnin
took all the knowledge of the Starlight
Citadel right so all information
containing the existence of the
Multiverse and everything that she knew
about the Multiverse and literally used
telepathy to put it in the mind of Ryan
Braddock and then cast him out right and
he basically ended up showing back up to
the Illuminati at some point in taught
but that's how the captain written core
fell now following the restoration of
the Multiverse the cap of written core
was not restored the reason for that is
because the method and manner of
choosing the Captain Britain Corps is
not arbitrary the sword of might or the
Amulet of right and in years past this
is kind of what saturnin says here in
years past Captain Britain's who were
chosen for that particular role had to
undergo that test what we're told here
is there are Captain britons out there
in the Multiverse but saturnin considers
him to be heretical she considers him to
be to to be Heretics because they have
not undergone the process of choosing
between the sword or the amulet and so
because they have not undergone that
traditional process they're not real
Captain britons for all intents and
purposes the way that saturnin views it
somebody just grabbed a Captain Britain
uniform slapped it on and now they're
that character right they're not the
rightful character they haven't
undergone the process a person should
undergo in order to become that in order
to overtake that role and so because of
that while there are Captain britons
there she's basically captured them and
she's holding them until she decides
when they're ready to be destroyed and
so in this frustration and this
irritation as far as Saturday is
concerned while Brian Braddock is not in
possession of the amulet he is in
possession of the of the sword and Brian
Braddock is the only true Captain
Britain that Betsy Braddock is not that
Betsy Braddock is considered to be a
heretic in the eyes of saturnin and this
really is kind of doubled down by
Betsy's own admission when saturnin
makes the case about The Sword and the
amulet and Betsy says I never had to
make either choice and that's when
Saturday is like those are your words
not mine in effect in the eyes of
saturnin Betsy Braddock doomed herself
and she basically gay saronin license to
take her captive right and that's what
she kind of says like the exits that way
right you don't need to be here like
there's no reason for you to be here now
as she goes to kind of make her way
she's met by Brian and the crazy thing
about this is that she kind of
challenges Brian to a fight right she's
like let's get this on right let's let's
figure this out once and for all like
who is the actual Captain written the
cool thing about this and what's
interesting here is that Brian's
response is I gave you the amulet if you
guys remember the Excalibur Story the
first one that we did his response was I
gave you the amulet because I was being
taken over by Morgan lafaye in this
moment when I was basically being
transformed into her henchman I did not
want her to have a henchman that had the
power of the amulet so I gave it to you
but this was only ever meant to be
temporary that ultimately I knew that
you guys would win against Morgan lafay
and when that time came I hoped that you
would give the amulet back to me that's
why I gave you this sword the response
of Betsy is I don't want to give it back
to you right I like being Captain
Britain I want to stay Captain Britain
like the whole idea of of of Brian
Braddock is but you don't even live in
England like you live in krakowa you
live in a whole different place what
kind of Captain Britain could you
possibly be if you don't even live in
the place you represent right it doesn't
really make any sense it's like a
president of the United States that
lives in Japan it's nonsensical there's
no it just it just doesn't work that way
right now at this point it's really just
kind of arguing geographic location but
if we're being honest with ourselves
because a a Captain Britain can become
that way by taking the sword or the
amulet then we're really just kind of
arguing semantics is really what's
happening here that's all this is coming
down to but the funny thing about this
is that as they kind of begin to get
into the to a little bit of their fight
Betsy Braddock does make a really good
point in saying that becoming Captain
Britain is an honor it's not a
Birthright right you're not owed this
you're not owed the role of Captain
Britain despite what the lineage is and
despite your ties to King Arthur you're
not owed this role you had this role
bestowed upon you at one point in time
but it could also have been taken away
and if it can be taken away from you
then it's not a thing that you
inherently own right it's a thing that's
just given to you for some temporary
amount of time even if that temporary
amount of time just happens to be your
entire life it can be taken away at any
point in time and so what you end up
doing here is you kind of have this this
whole situation that's kind of
interrupted right by saturnin you know
and she's like you guys need to calm
down but the funny thing about this is
she kind of seems to be sewing Discord
among the two right like she kind of
seems to be creating a rift among these
two now what we end up doing is picking
up later that night and when that
happens you end up having uh having you
know Jamie Jamie Braddock who's kind of
sleeping you know in his guest quarters
and is met by what are what's
essentially an assemblage of Captain
Britain's that are different other
different characters based on the X-Men
right so roku's a Captain Britain Gambit
who's a Captain Britain Jubilee that
kind of a thing and so the result of
this is that they basically say like we
sentence you to die right now the
motivation for why they sentenced him to
die we're not really given a definitive
explanation here instead what ends up
happening and and it kind of looks as
though Jamie may have sold them out but
but what it looks like happened here uh
at least what does happen here is you
have Betsy and you have Brian who of
course respond and then once they get in
there Jamie's got all these guys seized
right now again Jamie Brad a can warp
reality on a universal scale and that's
what those strings are right those
strings that emanate that's that's how
it is that he controls reality now this
has just kind of shown to us for
artistic license it's just kind of shown
to us like this is what he's actually
doing in terms of how it is at like
Betsy and Brian or Brian Braddock see if
he's just standing there and they're
floating in thin air and all hell's
popping loose right that's that's all it
kind of looks to them this just kind of
shows that we can get an artistic
understanding of how his powers work but
the whole point behind this is he's kind
of like okay they showed up here with
the intention of killing me I can't just
let that slide but you know if I can't
kill them all then I'll just kill one to
help them understand their place in the
bigger picture and so in doing that he
kills the captain written Jubilee right
he kills the Jubilee version of Captain
Britain and so once she's dead it pisses
off all the others right they go after
them and they end up taking off right
they end up basically bailing out Brian
Braddock ultimately ends up drawing the
sword of Might from the Scabbard and
when he does he becomes a version of
Captain Britain using the sword of Might
right now at that moment he in turn
turns it on the rest of the Captain
Britain core and says I will strike you
down if I have to I don't want to but I
will kill you if I have to but that's
when saturnin steps in and so she
basically she she kind of appeals to
Brian Braddock right with this idea kind
of kind of appealing to his his manly
nature right being a little romantic and
so on and saying like you know get rid
of this sort of my you don't need this
anymore right I am the sole occupant of
the Starlight Citadel Merlin and roma
are long dead I determine who's going to
be the captain of Britain from this
point going forward and so she basically
tells him get rid of the sword she tries
to strip the amulet away from Betsy
Braddock with the intention of giving it
to Brian but Betsy uses a combination of
her of her power along with some spells
that she learned from apocalypse and
destroys the amulet in the process now
the reason why this matters is because
the amulet is what gives cat though that
version of Captain Britain their power
right so like flight force field
different things like that suit you know
enhanced strength super speed so on and
so forth without the amulet those Powers
can't freely be given right it would
have to be restored or something along
those lines as a result of that she ends
up having Betsy Bradley taken away and
takes Brian to what is basically her bed
chamber and so as a result of this you
pick up with with Betsy Braddock right
kind of down in this this holding cell
and she kind of tries to reach out so
far she hasn't really been successful
but she tries to reach out and is
ultimately met by the Gambit version of
Captain Britain from the from whatever
alternate reality that happens to be and
what she basically says is at least
having this conversation with him she
asks like you know are you guys okay
right is everything okay and the the
funny thing is like she tells him like
we'll try like I'm gonna try to find a
way out out but what she's told by
Gambit is escaping the cells is no small
thing if all you had to do is pick a
lock and leave it wouldn't really be
much of a prison cell and so what he
tells her is there are spells that
surround this cell and the way in which
it works is that when Rogue tried to
break out she literally just tried to
fly out of it and got exceedingly cold
and she can't get any warm now right
like she got cold she got lost and she
can't warm up right so there's an effect
that it has on you it's that kind of
magic that keeps people contained within
these cells and so what ends up
happening is that while she's
telepathically communicating with Gambit
the Jimmy Braddock piggybacks onto their
their Communications right and says okay
so like you need to jump out jump out
the window now and I will catch you
right I mean they're so high up that if
you were to jump out you'd probably end
up getting yourself killed when you hit
the ground uh and the fact that she
doesn't really have the amulet means her
normal powers or the powers of Captain
Britain aren't readily available to her
now you could kind of ask the question
if she really is that powerful in terms
of her telekinesis why couldn't she just
fly that's a good question to ask I
don't know why we don't get an answer to
that but it kind of seems to be this
sort of revolving spell that exists
right they're like if she jumps out the
window then she gets caught up in the
spell and so the response to this of of
Jimmy Braddock is okay you could stay
here but keep in mind you're in other
world and they're gonna execute you with
Dawn so when you die like if you die or
when the time comes if you're executed
and you die they can bring you back on
grecoa but remember guys if you die in
other world and they resurrect you in
krakowa you come back all screwed up
right you come back all twisted and
screwed up we saw that in the last
couple videos that we made that's one of
the important points about dying in
other world that remains for the rest of
Swords of x if you die out there there's
no guarantee that the version of you
that comes back will be the person who
died it could be any other alternate
reality version of yourself right so
maybe Betsy Braddock jumps out or she's
executed in the morning and her color
resurrects her and she comes back it's
like some crazy some some absolutely
nuts girl who's hell-bent on world
domination right there's no way of
knowing if that's going to be the case
right no way of knowing what version of
her will come back and so because of
that you end up having her of course
making this leap of faith out the window
and then being caught by a griffin right
that belongs to uh to Jamie Braddock who
of course rescues her and the two of
them make their way towards saturnin's
bed chamber and as she's there what she
ends up doing is based basically telling
Brian Braddock you're the one that needs
to represent this prophecy right you're
the one that needs to to basically wield
this star-like sword not Betsy Braddock
she's not a real Captain Britain this
has to be you you have to be the one to
to wield this weapon and so what she
ends up doing is basically crafting The
Starlight sword itself now one of the
things to keep in mind here and this is
something that we we may not have really
covered or hadn't been too clear on is
that this whole idea that of course you
know once Betsy Braddock and them show
up you know and like literally you have
Saturday making out with Brian Braddock
right so you know like let's let's touch
naughty bits right you have like uh you
have you know Betsy and you have uh
Jamie who are kind of watching
everything go down and then Brian
Braddock realizes she's there and he's
like Betsy take the sword now right
Betsy runs in grabs the sword and we
realize that Brian Braddock was never
actually on the side of saturnin but he
was basically playing her in order to
give Betsy time to steal the Starlight
sword herself because that's part of the
prophecy for the swords of X event one
of the things to understand here is this
prophecy is not something that predates
saturnin right it's not as though it's a
prophecy that's been around for like
Millennia and it's just now coming to
fruition this is a game that's saturnin
herself created right she created the
prophecy she created all of this right
it's kind of her great big huge game to
just sort of see what happens we don't
really know what the end result of this
is we don't really know what it is that
she's trying to achieve what's the point
of standing in the way of the forces of
of arako that want to invade the main
Marvel Universe and kill everybody there
what's the point of that right if you're
the Starlight Citadel what's the whole
point I mean you're not really affected
by any of it so why does it matter to
you right we don't really know what the
end result of her whole campaign is what
we do know is this kind of of effort
between Brian and and Betty has
ultimately worked that what it's done is
this drove saturnin to create the
Starlight sword which was the missing
weapon that they needed in order to
secure the forces of Earth fighting
against the forces of Morocco and so now
they have both they have the sword of
Might and they have the Starlight sword
and so it solidifies this position right
and so from here it just boils down to
three more swords right all we have are
three more my question here and this is
a question that I feel like a lot of you
guys are asking my question here is when
are we going to see The Return of mad
Jim Jaspers that's what I want I want to
see Jim Jasper's come back I want to see
him and I want to see the fury
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back again with uh I guess
technically it's ten of Swords but I
like calling it extra swords I think it
just sounds more like an X-Men title
when you say it but uh but we are
picking back up with this what this does
this initially picks up with uh with
apocalypse right now remember apocalypse
has largely been in the healing Gardens
since his return from Otherworld in the
sense that when he was attacked by The
Four Horsemen uh that his body looked
like it was quite literally starting to
fall apart and his injuries are pretty
extreme right there's no real certainty
that he'll actually survive and so the
people of krakowa and really the the
mutants themselves are faced with a bit
of a predicament because of the fact
that apocalypse suffered as injuries in
other world and he would die here the
implication seems to be that while he
wouldn't necessarily die in other worlds
the effect of dying in other world
Remains the Same in the sense that we
don't know what version of him would
actually come back some alternate
reality version maybe like the Age of
Apocalypse version of himself where he's
just hell-bent on Conquering the world
and so the result of this is that the
healer is basically brought before him
for the purpose of restoring his
energies the problem with this is the
Healer cannot actually heal apocalypse
on his own one because of the fact that
apocalypse keeps fighting you know and
all that kind of stuff because of how
much pain he's in and so you end up
basically having Polaris and Magneto use
their combined powers to strap him down
but also because the healer is just not
powerful enough in his own right and so
the conversation begins to shift by
Charles Xavier to having Hope Summers
amplify the powers of healer the issue
with that is this hasn't really been
done before and we don't know what the
effect would be if it would actually
kill apocalypse if it would help him
survive there's no real knowing but
apocalypse's response is do it right if
I'm strong enough I'll survive the
ordeal and if I'm not then I'll know I'm
weak and so in this point apocalypse
undergoes the healing at the hands of
the Healer whose power is boosted by
Hope Summers and this is when we get
this really really cool explanation as
to why it is that apocalypse is so
hell-bent on testing people because one
of the things that we saw in the early
days of of Marvel Comics and really kind
of the origin that we got from back in
the day is that apocalypse was
discovered by ball and the sandstormers
right they're kind of like this Nomad
group that was out there and he was
taught by ball the philosophy of
survival of the fittest what this does
is this Jonathan Hickman coming back and
completely retelling the origin of
Apocalypse right it's a whole new origin
in relation to how it how it's based on
apocalypse's desire to test people
that's kind of the funny thing here is
that apocalypse leaving you know and
there is a little bit of wiggle room
there and we'll kind of talk about why
this wiggle room is important here in a
second but it's basically kind of a
flashback sort of kind of consolidating
a lot of what we were told up to this
point and the idea was that somewhere
along the line when you had uh krakowa
and arako that they were a singular
Nation that's something that we've
talked about over the course of time
these were two single islands and that's
somewhere out of nowhere you basically
ended up getting these forces of evil
right these these kind of demonic
entities that invaded the world and
because okara which is what it was
called at the time was basically you
know these two uh you know arako and
gracoa existing as a single Island
because okara was effectively a mutant
Haven right it was a land where mutants
resided those individuals who had popped
up around that time that were largely
led by apocalypse because this was a a
safe haven that this is one of the first
places to fall because it was one of the
first places where the horde initially
popped up and so what you ended up
getting was basically the 100 soldiers
right you ended up getting the white
sword who is basically a champion right
he was a champion seemingly of the
people on this island so maybe
apocalypse didn't necessarily rule over
them per se but him and the 100 went
into the portal right they passed into
that realm and basically ended up facing
off against all these forces right these
forces of ameth and when that happened
that you of course also had Genesis the
wife of Apocalypse who stepped in as
well and helped to basically you know
curtail these forces and send them back
the problem with that is you ended up
having a situation where a manth
actually ended up contacting apocalypse
directly right and this comes by virtue
of basically the Helm of aminth being
brought forward to apocalypse by the the
forces of these demons right by all
these different demons and monsters and
so on and so when one of them opens the
box he realizes it's the helm and
immediately panicked right but he's told
by one of the other guys and you know
Annihilation will walk the land is
basically all gods made men do and so
put the helmet on right like put this
thing on and then when that happens
basically aminth takes over this person
now the way this Helm is explained to us
by Jonathan Hickman the helm itself is
kind of like possessed by this sort of
demonic entity but we're not given a
full-on explanation here right we're not
giving any full answers in terms of who
ameth is or or what their place is or or
where they come from or any of that
stuff it's just some kind of demonic
being that exists out there now it
really comes straight from the horse's
mouth right that you know Hickman tells
us aminth is a Black Planet of Black
Death a hellscape of demons and things
of a darker origin a chaos world of wild
space that would be completely
uncontrollable to the living if not for
the golden Helm of annihilation that
commands the conquered horde of aminth
the person who wears the helm rules that
dark world but the helm itself rules the
wearer possessed by some elder god a
primordial force of the spirit of that
world made manifest the helm is
seductive the helm is all-consuming and
only a wearer of Greater strength and
power can hope to live through the
experience right it's a crown for the
fit and only the fit can rule the
amenity hell right so this this Spirit
basically or this this being it's almost
kind of like a the essence of this
demonic world that all these forces come
from right now we again we don't really
know what's goal or its ambition but the
long and short is that when it possesses
this demon and it starts speaking
directly to apocalypse that it says I'm
giving you an offering but I cannot give
it to you freely right I must test you I
must know whether or not you're worthy
of receiving this offering and so what
ends up happening is a couple of these
demons basically challenge uh apocalypse
as forces specifically Genesis and
initially it was going to be apocalypse
himself who was going to challenge these
guys but you know the ones who receive
the offering or the one to undergo the
test to determine whether or not they
were worth receiving the offering but
instead his wife Genesis steps up and
when that happens she basically uses her
power seemingly over the Earth to
destroy or to defeat these two you know
these two demonic beings and then in
turn you end up having this this kind of
offer that's made to her by you know
this this you know a minty demon right
by payment basically and when that
happens we don't really know what the
offer was that was made to the wife of
Apocalypse in Genesis herself instead
all we know is that in the aftermath of
this that basically they had to travel
to that realm and they had to close the
rift right they had to close that portal
and cut acara in half that's kind of
what led to that right that's what led
to uh krakowa becoming its own Island
and arako becoming its own place inside
of of other world basically and so in
that moment that's when when essentially
the idea seems to be that like a future
battle will be fought right that like
you know we will give you safe haven or
whatever it is or we I have no real idea
but like in the future you know things
are going to pop off and so with that
being the case Genesis tasks her husband
with testing right she says you're not
strong enough to follow me to this realm
stay and use the time that we buy you to
make this world into something that can
stand against our enemy right judge them
my love judge them all and that's why
apocalypse does what he does he's tasks
or he was tasked by his wife to travel
the world and to basically make it a
place where Only the Strong could
survive because at some future point and
time the strong would be the only ones
capable of surviving against this coming
horde of of the amenthy army right so
apocalypse has quite literally been
following this philosophy in order to
repair the world for this Army that is
set to invade and then unleash all kinds
of holy hell right so that's really the
whole idea behind this it's why
apocalypse does what he does this is a
massive change to his entire history
right because we didn't really know the
the kind of blanks that were being left
there right kind of referencing what we
talked about you know earlier when we
said that we would come come back and
explain this that the traditional
history of Apocalypse is that he was
discovered by ball and the sandstormers
when he was a baby he was taken under
their wing he was taught the philosophy
that Only the Strong deserved to survive
this kind of social darwinist ideology
but the origin at the time was that was
an ideology that ball had that was an
ideology his tribe had and they passed
that ideology onto apocalypse and that's
why he does what he does what Hickman's
doing here is coming in and saying none
of that's true the reason why apocalypse
tests the world the way he does is
because he knew a conflict was going to
be coming at some future point in time
right five thousand years Ten Thousand
Years twenty thousand years in the
future and he's constantly been been
testing the world in order to make sure
it's strong enough to survive it this
completely changes the motivation for
why apocalypse does what he does it's
not because he's a dick it's because
he's been trying to make sure the world
can save itself right that's a huge
change it's a massive change and so once
he fully recovers he ends up traveling
to uh to to the Libyan Desert right in
Western Egypt to the Temple of the Four
Horsemen right to the Temple of the
horsemen and and really to his own
resting place and when he gets there of
course he goes inside and then he
basically ends up taking a sword and and
essentially grabs a sword and then
travels back to take his place really
it's as seemingly the final piece on the
the swords of X landscape the final
piece that's here uh as part of the
extra swords event and the final hero
among krakowa who's gonna face off
against the forces of Morocco
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are picking back up again with the
swords of X event and this sees the
return of one of my favorite villains of
all time in the history of Marvel Comics
you guys know exactly who I'm talking
about the downside of this is we see him
once
that's all we get so what we initially
have here is an emissary right an
invitation to a contest of Worlds
basically saying we invite you to see
the the battle between the forces of
arako and the forces of krakowa now a
lot of you guys have kind of been
wondering or at least kind of Express a
little bit of confusion in terms of
what's going on here to kind of sum this
all down the nature of what's going on
with X of Swords The Argus 10 of Swords
whatever you want to call it the whole
reason why this is taking place is
because apocalypse when he opened the
gate the external gate that basically
allows access between krakowa and
Otherworld his goal was to use that gate
to access arako to rescue his wife and
his children The Four Horsemen and then
bring them back to krakowa and basically
unite his family what he ended up
discovering and what we discovered is
that what you also had going on were
called the forces of Ammon and the
forces of aminth managed to breach their
own realm and then eventually they were
taken over by The Four Horsemen so the
four horsemen lead the army of Ammon and
so when apocalypse entered Otherworld
where the intention of reuniting his
family that he discovered he family had
basically become bad guys right like his
his kids basically became villains and
they were leading this Army and they
intended to basically use the Kirk Cohen
gate they granted access to Otherworld
to pass through that gate into krakowa
and then conquer cocoa and the rest of
the world right so it was it's kind of
like you know I want to get my kids back
oh my God they're villains and the whole
reason why this matters is because in
order to settle the affair right in
order to basically keep like all-out war
between the forces of krakowa and the
forces of arako emerging odd saturnin
basically created this contest right
created this this whole really big huge
tournament and whoever wins will be the
one who decides or who kind of gets what
it is that they want right so if the
four horsemen if apocalypse's kids win
the tournament then they lead the army
of aminth into krakowa if the forces of
krakowin then the army of aminth
whatever happens to them happens to them
and that's why we are where we are right
now so just a quick little synopsis kind
of a quick explanation I get that some
of you guys are a little confusing it's
the nature of going through Jonathan
Hickman's work kind of piece by piece is
that it's one of these things where he
reads much better in trade it's much
much better to read Jonathan Hickman's
stories when it's all done and you're
going to get the trade paperbacks right
it makes everything make a lot more
sense but the uh the Emissary has
basically appeared here to Mad Jim
Jaspers in the Crooked market right and
basically saying this is your invitation
to show up here to this tournament to
become a part of it right to kind of
watch everything unfold and that's the
last time we see Jim Jaspers in this
comic but here's the funny thing about
this right here's the funny thing about
what Hickman's gonna end up doing here
Jonathan Hickman with with mad Jim
Jasper's it could go one of two ways
right we could see mad Jim Jasper's pop
off we could see him just lose his mind
and this crazy Display of Power in the
next issue we may not see him again for
another five issues right it could be
that we see him in like the background
during the whole tournament and then we
don't actually see him do anything for
another 50 issues there's no telling
with Jonathan Hickman right we have no
idea Jonathan Hickman writes for the
long game right he writes for the
conclusion of the story so it's kind of
the nature of the Beast right it's the
nature of these things and so because of
that the next thing is that the the
Emissary visits the kingdom of
and then of course visits the infuri at
the everforge now the infuri and really
the fury themselves the fact that
there's more than one is kind of
terrifying the fury are wildly powerful
beings right so to kind of give you guys
a little bit of an uh explanation here
when mad Jim Jasper's originally
appeared in Marvel Comics he was part of
a universe called Earth 238 and this was
a universe where he basically killed all
the superheroes but Jim Jaspers didn't
do it on his own instead what he did is
he used his powers to warp reality to
create the fury and the fury was a being
that had the ability to adapt to
anybody's powers and then overcome them
it's how the fury was able to defeat Jim
Jaspers from the main Marvel Universe
when the fury showed up inside the main
Marvel universe or at least the First
Time The Fury killed him the two of them
actually ended up coming back there's a
story that we haven't covered called
X-Men Die By The Sword I think where Jim
Jaspers comes back but uh but the whole
idea here is that the fury realized that
the only way the Jim Jasper's Powers
work is if he has a universe to alter
and so he took him to where the Earth
238 Universe was at before before it was
destroyed and then basically obliterated
him right because he realized that in
this giant empty space where there is no
matter the gym Jasper's was powerless
right so the fact that there's like an
entire place here full of Furies is kind
of nuts they are weapon forgers they
create like these basically basically
like these unbreakable weapons and all
of reality like in the entirety of the
Multiverse because remember what we're
dealing with here are multiversal
locations people from different
universes can access these different
places like the qriket market apocalypse
from like you know the Age of Apocalypse
Universe could access this and like
characters from like the Days of Future
Past Universe could access this feasibly
if they decided to include it the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Doctor Strange could
travel to this place right this it's
kind of kind of Bonkers so we're dealing
with things in a much larger scale these
aren't planets these are whole Universal
territories right little pocket
Dimensions you've also got the holy
Republic of the FAE you've got the
floating Kingdom of roma roma Regina
this is basically Merlin and uh and roma
they were previously the ones who ruled
over Otherworld before the events of the
incursions the death of the uh of the
whole Captain Britain Corps and the fact
that they just kind of ended up going to
war with each other but in their absence
it allowed saturnin to Take Over Control
of other world and that's why she is
where she is but nonetheless you know
following these these kind of emissaries
or this Emissary that's sent out in
these invitations that are given to
these various people we pick up with
what are called the foul and fair courts
and this is basically a kind of coming
together of these various courts some of
which we see here and some of which we
don't for example you don't see Jim
Jasper's here who's considered part of
the foul Court probably because he's
just like I have other things to do
besides show up here you see the furies
who are here they're considered part of
the fair Court Hickman doesn't really
play it solid insofar as saying the fair
Court are good guys the foul court or
bad guys we're not really given a given
a kind of knock down explanation that
way we can kind of assume maybe it is
but historically Merlin is a dick and
the fact that he's part of the of the
foul Court kind of makes sense but Rome
has been a little you know weird too
sometimes and so there's been a few
times where she's been a little bit
villainous in her actions and so again
it kind of seems to follow that ideology
but again we're not given like an actual
definitive active explanation here
instead the whole purpose behind the
assembling of this chord is basically
for the blights blight spokes to be
allowed access across like any of the
dimensions that they want to now we're
not really given a whole lot of
information about the blight spoke and
in fact this is all we really seem to
see of them right you guys Sheriff uh
Gia White Chapel of the blight spoke and
that's really it uh their request is
denied and that's that's really all you
get here but it's a little bit of kind
of a court thing but the reason why
Hickman does this is because this will
be important later on down the line
right there's a reason why he gives us
this and so for the most part we can
kind of take this little bit of a scene
we can sit it on the back burner and
then come back to it at a future point
in time uh but the the important thing
to kind of come out of this is that at
the conclusion of this meeting
essentially you end up having saturnin
who asks the the current Horsemen who
are there uh you know like pestilence
and War while you were Rocco forces
currently prepared to engage in this
conflict and their answer is yes and
then of course yes Jamie Braddock what
about your forces on krakowa and he's
like they're on their way right so
basically this is a coming together of
the Warriors right they're all basically
arriving in other world and then the
tournament will commence after that
right and so when what we end up doing
here is transitioning to gracoa and
apocalypse talking to all the the sword
bearers right and he gives like the
worst speech ever he's like okay guys
don't die because if you do then you're
gonna come back and some weird Twisted
version all right let's go and that's
basically it and instead you know the
the statement's kind of like I mean you
should kind of give us a little bit of
like a pep talk right I mean you know
it's like like literally uh like he was
like I mean can you like um it couldn't
hurt right if you give us some kind of a
pep talk and so he does and it's
actually this epic pep talk right he
says like sword Bears most of you are
mutant you have tasted the sweetness of
immortality and evolution of our people
meaning the fact that they can die and
always come back now we step into the
other world where all realities are one
and your defeat will mean the death of
krakowa the death of this earth and the
death of you as you are now never to
return so when you draw your sword you
must not fight like a human who stands
to lose a few years of toil but like a
mutant who stands to lose forever and
Paradise for if you do not you will not
be the first Immortals I will have
watched die it's a crazy it's a really
really cool thing it's a pretty epic
speech right it's a pretty awesome
speech there and so what we end up doing
is picking up with these various forces
of gracoa and arako all showing up here
right and initially it starts with
Captain Britain showing up here along
Wolverine cable and so on they all
basically teleport in at the same time
but when they do it's kind of like okay
like they're immediately on their guard
right because they don't know if they're
teleporting in here and then the battle
immediately starts they don't know if
they're teleporting in here and there's
going to be a lot of Pomp and
Circumstance right a great big huge kind
of recession or you know kind of Welcome
to the the 10fx event you know and so on
and so forth you know and like you got
Michael Buffer there you know in this
side of the Ring standing at five foot
two weighing some ridiculous number
because his bones are covered in in
Unbreakable metal Wolverine like we
don't really know if that's that's
though that's what we're going to get
right I think it'd be awesome if like
Michael Buffer showed up here and
offered a kind of speech all right I
think it'd be pretty cool but saturnain
finally makes your appearance and
basically tells everybody you guys need
to chill right you know like like relax
the tournament's not starting yet it
will start soon your fellow combatants
are going to be arriving here and it'll
be a chance for you guys to meet so head
to your quarters they've all been
prepared for you and when they arrive
there they're all given their respective
cards remember these were cards that
were created by saturnin explicitly for
them but the cards do not necessarily
mean what they appear to be on their
faces for example uh you end up having
cable who's given the card of the fool
and it doesn't mean the cable is an
actual fool even though he thinks that's
what it means instead it's the Journey
of the fool which is to say he doesn't
know everything yet but he will learn a
lot as time goes on this really kind of
seems to be around about way of John and
Hickman saying the powers of cable are
going to expand or Cable's own
individual story is going to become a
lot more grandiose than it currently is
but then of course you end up having
apocalypse who reads his gets angry and
throws it away and so what he ends up
doing is traveling to meet saturnin and
this common a conversation between these
two is wildly intriguing and and that's
what makes Hickman's you know acts of
Swords so cool is because you see
characters meeting whom you would never
see meet under any other circumstance
and watching how they interact is really
intriguing for example like saturnin was
never really the most powerful character
ever it wasn't until she took over
Otherworld and then started using all
the Magics at its disposal to to utilize
you know to really rule this place that
she became as powerful as she is prior
to this she was basically a figurehead
right she was the omniversal magistrict
she was not on par with like the Living
Tribunal or something like that she just
kind of played more of a gubernatorial
role in relation to like how the
Multiverse functions you know if you
kind of broke it down into different
positions she played more of the
governing body uh with regards to the
Living Tribunal he played like the power
source now neither one really associated
with the other it's not like you would
see meetings of the omniversal
development chord and like the living
tribunals out there in the third row
watching it all go down you would never
really see that instead it was just it
was kind of doing its own thing it was
part of this wildly intricate hierarchy
of how the Multiverse you know how it's
fun government function is maintained
the funny thing about that though is the
omniversal development Court was
sometimes acknowledged and sometimes
ignored by Marvel Comics depending on
who the writer was you know for example
you never really hadn't seen it for like
I want to say it didn't appear for like
a decade until you got to the incursions
right I mean you had Spider-Man UK and
you had a few appearances here and there
but like in those five years that Marvel
was leading up to Secret Wars you saw it
multitude a multitude of times prior to
that you never really saw it at all
right and you probably wouldn't have
known and existed unless you were
reading the right kind of comics uh and
even then it didn't really appear all
that often in Excalibur so it's one of
these interesting things that's kind of
the nature of the nature of how it all
works Marvel's never really Consolidated
it they never really kind of explained
like what's the nature of the omniversal
development chord in comparison to The
Living Tribunal does like the one above
all is he part of this like was he was
he the one that kind of engineered that
how does it compare to like the fulcrum
and the Neil Gaiman comics for for the
eternals we don't really know right
we're not really given an explanation
here uh but with apocalypse showing up
here and basically meeting her the
question is I don't really like what
what I'm seeing here right like I don't
really like what's going on I don't
really like this game you're playing
answer me right like what's the meaning
of these taunts of all this nonsense but
notice saturnin doesn't really take him
seriously now one of the big things
about her character about Saturday's
character historically is she always had
a kind of arrogance right there was
always a kind of arrogance about her in
the sense of I'm above you I'm way above
I'm way you know much higher above you
than anybody else's rightly you know
it's just the nature of things you know
in terms of of power probably not or at
least you know before she became ruler
of other worlds she's nowhere near above
apocalypse but even apocalypse plays it
a little haughty right he's like
answered me before you know explain
yourself before I become angry well he's
literally in the in the like he's in the
Lion's Den right he's in the belly of
the Beast what is he gonna do like
there's no power he possesses that could
overcome saturnin I guess maybe he could
just start like smashing the Twilight
Citadel right just like you know
smashing his fists and knocking off
giant chunks of it and just more or less
like inconveniencing her but that would
be about it
that'd be about all that he could do in
this situation but one of the things she
says is she's like I'm kind of intrigued
by you you really are one of the oldest
beings in existence right in in you know
on your Earth not across your entire
universe right relative to the history
of the universe you're but a speck right
you've been you've been alive for a
fraction of a second but in terms of the
history of your Earth you've been around
for a relatively lengthy amount of time
I mean even within the history of the
Earth right it's still kind of a
fraction of a second but in comparison
to the evolution of your race of mutant
kind you've been around for a long long
time and even in comparison to the
length of humanity you've been around
for a pretty lengthy amount of time but
I'm interested I'm kind of curious about
you right all this power that you
possess you beat Morgan lafay right in
like a straight up battle that's
interesting but what you've done here is
you've bullied yourself in you've
basically played the role of somebody
who's lesser than yourself and once it
was all said and done the only reason
you even got here is because I invited
you so ask yourself the question is it
kind of an insult to know that no matter
what your best efforts were you only got
in here because I allowed it but even
kind of continuing this taunting and
even when he says like are you trying to
provoke me you know at the end of the
day she still just kind of plays it fast
and loose and she still doesn't really
take him uh take him seriously more so
than that she's like you're a very very
old being I'm surprised that you're
acting so impatient here you really
shouldn't be acting this impatient right
you've been around long enough you
should have more patience than almost
anybody else here you're playing a game
that you've been working on for
Millennia and here at the Finish Line
you're gonna suddenly grow impatient but
the funny thing about this is that it
reveals the very Human Side of
Apocalypse in the sense of of course he
does like he's just about done like
which one of us doesn't find our second
win when we're that close to the Finish
Line right that's kind of where he is
you know this kind of new method this
new step of of zealousness that's going
on with this character and so with
saturnin who was already on her way to a
meeting she invites apocalypse alone and
this is one of those things where it
seems to be kind of designed to more or
less play games but when he enters into
this meeting room he's met by an
individual who is wearing what's
basically the the helmet of aminth the
helmet uh the helmet of this of this
demon entity and as we explained in the
last video those individuals who wear it
become the voice of aminth itself I
really say itself because we don't
really know if this demon is like a man
or a woman or anything about them
whatsoever but they basically become the
person or kind of stand in as the person
who's leading this whole Force right and
so this person that she's meeting with
is effectively the person who's leading
The Four Horsemen who in turn are
leading the army of Ammon right so this
person is basically apocalypse's enemy
because we we know that by virtue of the
various swords and who's going to be
fighting who that apocalypse is destined
to fight this person and when this
person goes and removes their mask we
won see the card of Apocalypse it says
the lovers and then two it's
apocalypse's wife it's Genesis this
means that during the tournament
apocalypse is going to have to fight and
he's going to have to kill his wife this
is a bold move by saturnin because if it
goes awry say for example the Genesis is
a turncoat say for example that she's
operating under this role but isn't
actually allied with Ammon or her
children The Four Horsemen and is
actually working directly alongside
apocalypse remember they had that
conversation before she went to the
portal prepare the world for what's
coming if she really has maintained her
Solitude all this time and she really is
a good guy all this time then things
could pop off fast it could pop off so
quickly and go south so astronomically
fast right there's there's no telling
what's gonna happen here but I know it I
know it doesn't seem overly surprised
like I know it doesn't seem like this
great big huge crazy grandiose event but
this right here could easily turn into
the turn of the tide and everything
saturnine's built could come Crashing
Down
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are picking back up again
with uh swords of X and in this video
we're focusing on the return of mad Jim
Jaspers yes we are but before we get
into that we're gonna pick up with a
couple little fun things that happen
here a couple little small things the
first part of this focuses on X-Men
Issue Number 14 but this is really just
Exposition and the reality is we don't
really learn a lot that we didn't
already know before but there are a
couple things that we do pick up here
the first of these things really comes
with the Twilight Sword and the Twilight
sword of course as is being wielded by
apocalypse's wife Genesis is a weapon
that's part of the Ten of Swords or
exoswords event right it's one of the
things that the forces of Morocco had to
gather in order to fight against the
forces of krakowa but as I was reading
this and as yesterday was basically kind
of retelling this origin of mutant kind
at least as it existed on okara which is
originally what kurkoa and arako were
before they were split into we of course
get the same Expedition that we always
did right the Twilight sword of the
enemy tore the world asunder and what
was one became two and I started
thinking about this right now it says
after that happened that all the enemies
of aminth basically poured into the
world where I poured into the main
Marvel Universe right so they came from
this other place right just this this
kind of you know other other dimension
and it led to you know it led to them
invading the world and seeking to
capture it for the most part now of
course as a result of that you saw two
things happening you saw apocalypse
leading the mutant population against
the forces of Ammon and then you saw
what was basically the the white sword
right so this you know external this
Immortal mutant who basically has the
ability to resurrect you know him and
his 100 soldiers every single morning to
kind of fight the fight again that they
went through the portal alongside with a
alongside apocalypse's wife and the
various mutants who were there for the
purpose of trying to fight these forces
back right now of course we know that
just by virtue of the the stories that
we read that the promise apocalypse made
to his wife is he would prepare the
world as a place that could hold itself
against the forces of Amit which is why
he's always maintained this kind of uh
survival of the fittest mentality right
this is something that you can find in
our video that we did on the new origin
of Apocalypse in our X-Men playlist
where you can get totally caught up on
the the extra swords event right the Ten
of Swords event but the more I thought
about this and this is what's so cool
the more I thought about this was
specifically the Twilight sword of the
enemy and how his forces how the forces
you know once it's twilight once the
Twilight sword emerged that the enemy
basically escaped that like all these
forces came pouring out if I'm a betting
man I think that's Sorter and here's a
reason why if you go back and you look
at journey into mystery number 97 from
way back in the day what you had was a
story whereby Odin ended up facing off
against cerder and this led to Serta
being locked inside the earth now at
some future point in time and we're not
really told when Sutter managed to get
out right soda escaped and then just
kind of showed up somewhere along the
line this was back in the day when
Marvel wouldn't necessarily provide
these clear-cut explanations in terms of
how a leads into b instead it was just
you get the end of a and then you're
into B and then we don't you don't
really get a lot of connecting of the
dots that's what made Chris claremont's
style of writing so Landmark was because
of the fact that he did that for 17
years right it was it was a huge thing
to kind of keep the story narrative
going and everything tied into
everything else but if Serta managed to
escape Earth then this was this would
explain the Earth kind you know this
land cracking in two right it just
happened to be where sort of emerged
from but the reason why I say him and
nobody else is because as you guys know
the main weapon of Sir is a Twilight
sword and so it makes perfect sense that
Serta basically emerged with a Twilight
sword and then went and did his thing
right and then from there you know all
these enemy forces came pouring out and
who in the heck knows where it was that
they came from right but the long and
short of this is that with that bit of
an explanation being offered there that
Genesis has kind of emerged here as a
person who is in effect the leader of of
seemingly everybody right now initially
she donned the golden Helm of
annihilation which we talked about
before because it was what would allow
her to control the forces of Ammon right
and again we're not really given a lot
of indication here what what she really
points here is this notion that the
forces of amines are effectively
leaderless and that the individual who
wields the golden Helm is the person who
can control them and so it stands to
reason that if Serta was locked inside
Earth by Odin and Serta basically formed
this private Army for himself in the
forces of aminth and then somewhere
along the line soda escaped that he
would just leave them all behind and so
without any real leader the individual
who dons the golden Helm basically takes
over that role the problem with this is
that the golden Helm cannot be
controlled and so just because you put
it on and just because the golden Helm
will allow you to control the forces of
ameth does not mean you can control the
golden Helm and that's what she says
that the will of the golden Helm is now
her will and the golden Helm wanted to
get into krakowa and so she does as well
and that's why she's basically a villain
here because her stance is we're going
to end up fighting each other to the
death and her whole goal is to win the
contest or at least for for arako to win
the contest so they can invade krakowa
so that's the whole motivation behind
her character and that's how I think
cerder ties into all this stuff but for
the the goody stuff here right the the
good little tidbit here this is when we
pick up with Jim Jaspers because I feel
like that's what you guys really want to
see right you guys really really really
want to see this so here's a cool thing
that happens here right off the bat
right we pick up with the Crooked market
and you've got Jim Jaspers right and
he's basically telling his guys like be
super quick right like saturnine will
not tolerate us missing so much as a
single grain of salt right the Crooked
Market are the ones who are Supply
buying the various foods and things like
that for this great big huge feast and
this Feast is being held in honor of the
various people who are here that are
fighting now this is not uncommon and in
fact this is really Jonathan Hickman
borrowing from days gone by in older
years it was common that when you had a
War or conflict going on between two
territories it was designed to settle a
dispute and the conflict was being held
in the location of a of a non-partisan
third party that third party would
actually honor both groups and basically
bring forth their Champions and then
they would all Feast knowing full well
they were probably going to kill each
other in the morning but that was just
kind of the way that things were done
back then right there was a lot of
emphasis put on decorum and really the
ceremonial aspect of what it meant to
get involved in a conflict Now
understand there's no love loss here
just because they're all sharing dinner
here does not mean they're going to be
good friends
you know you even have things like like
you've got Cipher who's out there kind
of minding his own business you've got
storm who looks like she's kind of
flirting with Anubis it looks like
Anubis anyway and then of course you
also have Wolverine who's just kind of
being standoffish because of Wolverine
and that's what he does right he's just
standoffish guy but the doors officially
open the banners basically fall in the
hall and then it's everybody make your
way in and as they get in here it's
actually an incredible sight to behold
and that was one of the things about
Saturday right she was nothing if not
somebody who liked everyone to know just
how good she had it but you end up
getting this really cool situation where
we're basically introduced to Jaspers
right where Jaspers is officially
recognized and declared here and it's
like all of this is brought To Us by Jim
Jaspers of the Crooked market right we
also get lady Roma of the FAE you get
vesperide the colony Queen of the the
hofhive or the hot Hive whatever you
want to call it famine who's basically
the region of the former Kingdom of
dryador and then Jim Jasper's kind of
comments and says well you may not be
welcome in the dryador but you are
always welcome to my crooked market
right if you come there you can find
virtually anything that you want but
here's a funny thing about this right
here's so here's what's so crazy about
this and it's something super easy to
overlook here Jim Jaspers is acting
incredibly casual here he's like yeah I
mean come to the Crooked Market if you
have to but let's not be naive about
this guy Jim Jaspers is a guy who was so
powerful that his alternate reality
counterpart was a threat to the entire
Multiverse they had to kill his Universe
they had to wipe his Universe out in
order to save the Multiverse and he was
still weaker than this version of Jim
Jasper's here this guy is a multiversal
force that's all this guy is right this
guy is just death incarnate there are
very few things very precious few things
that could stand in the face of Jim
Jaspers now this guy is ridiculously
overpowered now how his power compares
to saturnin I'm not really sure and I
would really say just pump circumstance
and just being being polite here is the
only thing that's keeping Jim Jaspers
from just being like you know what I'm
bored let's turn everybody into cupcakes
and then stomp on right I feel like
that's the only thing that's stopping
him from doing that or just waving his
hand and turning everybody into blobs of
goo and that's the end of them no one
here could stop Jim Jaspers if he got
bored and decided to kill everybody
that's kind of what I'm telling you here
right that's how powerful this guy is
that's how powerful Jim Jaspers is and
that's why it's so incredibly exciting
to see him back because I feel like
things are going to pop off in this
place now the other funny thing that
happens here is you've got Ryan Braddock
right and Brian Braddock is here just
kind of you know doing his thing and
just sort of chilling out and Wolverine
walks up on him and he's like look man
you had an opportunity to basically stop
all this right like when saturnin took
you to her took you to her bed Chambers
and you guys were gonna do you know you
guys are gonna do the thing you know
you're gonna You're Gonna Knock boots
like you could have just gone through
with it right and then like none of this
would have happened in the first place
you know he's like well I'm a married
man he's like well here's the thing
though man like you know if you really
cared about all of us you would have
taken one for the team it's what I would
have done
you know I would have taken one for the
team and just called it a day it's kind
of a funny little thing obviously no
respectable man would do that but you
know Wolverine is not really a
respectable guy right and so what he
really does here is he kind of looks at
Brian Braddock is the reason for this
whole problem he's like you know I'm not
really going to be watching anybody out
there who's who's most likely going to
die instead I'm going to be watching you
I'm gonna be keeping my eye on you and
I'm gonna know that with all the people
who die from cocoa if any end up dying
tomorrow at all they will all have died
because of you now the other part of
this comes with Gordon and Ileana
Rasputin now Gorgon is a guy that we
haven't really covered too much in
Marvel Comics in fact I think the only
time we really offered any measure of
explanation on him was during the events
of secret Empire because he was part of
the Hydra Inner Circle and so we could
do with a bear a bit of explanation here
the idea behind gorgon's powers and the
reason why he wears the mask the way he
does is because he essentially has the
powers of Medusa if he were to take his
mask off anywhere to look at you you
would turn to Stone and so he wears that
mask in order to prevent that from
happening the problem with this is it
takes away his eyesight and so Gorgon is
a guy who is by all standards a
measurement blind even if only because
he chooses to be but he's also probably
one of the best fighters in all of
Marvel Comics when I say all of Marvel
Comics I mean all of Marvel Comics like
this guy could give almost anybody a run
for their money and it doesn't really
matter who it is the other part of this
is that with him and Magic sizing up
everybody here you've also got iska now
iska as a lot of you guys if you may
recall she's a person whose mutant power
is that she can't lose and so if for
example she you know she's part of this
whole great big huge tournament and her
mutant power you know because she can't
lose is that things going the way they
are it's obvious the forces of gracoa
are going to win she turned against the
forces of Morocco it's just the nature
of her powers now what Marvel doesn't
really explain here and this is the
problem you have or the power that's
this ambiguous is it passive or is it
active when it comes to powers and
Marvel Comics you have active and
passive powers and even in DC it works
the exact same way so something like
Superman's frost breath that's an active
power right he actually has to blow
Frost wrath at somebody but something
like Wolverine's healing factor is a
passive power he doesn't have to do
anything it just automatically happens
and so we don't know if that's the case
with her or if it's active or is passive
we don't really know we don't know if
like you know she allies with with
krakowa I'm sorry with the Rocco because
she's foreseen that arako is going to
win we don't know if she allies with
krakowa or if she ends up turning
against the Rocco and allies with kokoa
because her mutant power tells her Kirko
is going to win we don't really know
marvel hasn't really taken the time to
explain it it may be one of these things
where Hickman kind of gives us this bit
keys and we don't find out how our
powers work for 100 issues right that's
entirely possible but the cool thing
about this is that because they're aware
of iska's ability the question is which
side does she favor does she favor her
left side her right side how deep do her
powers go right that's a question of
organ and magic and so what they end up
doing is basically kind of you know
approaching her offering a bit of small
talk obviously giving her a little bit
of a hard time and then as a test they
drop their glasses at the same time and
because she's ambidextrous she catches
them both and doesn't drop one drop of
it and so it's like okay like of course
she's ambidextrous if she can't lose she
has all the skills she needs to succeed
and so she doesn't really favor her left
or her right side in fighting and so she
doesn't really have an infinitive
weakness in terms of her fighting style
in turn she pulls the same stun on on
Magic and and Gorgon and then magic
opens a portal that caused them to fall
back through and then of course it's
like you know we caught him so again
it's one of these cool things where
these foes these various Fighters are
learning a lot about each other because
understand this is the first time all of
them are meeting each other which is
kind of it was a really really cool in
here it's the first time that they're
all meeting each other and so when you
have this bit of a discussion here you
actually end up having us having storm
who approaches the horsemen death and
the two of them all start talking you
know the two of them kind of have this
great big huge conversation now there is
a bit of a tease and so far as maybe
storm is kind of romantically attracted
to him maybe it's this kind of Devil May
care or a bit of a mystery or Intrigue
but one thing to understand about storm
she's not some wide-eyed girl who just
stepped out into the world she's not
naive right she's not a naive person and
so while she is kind of entertaining
this possibility that there could be a
romance between her and The Horseman
death she basically ends it fast right
and she's like I've I've danced with
your kind before and I was curious what
kind of person you were because I'm
gonna be fighting you and now that I
know what kind of person you are I know
that one you're an honorable and
respectable person but two I know that I
wouldn't really have any qualms with
killing you and so from there he kind of
picks up with saturnin speaking directly
with with Wolverine right and Wolverine
is really just kind of pissed right he's
just walking around like a big grunt
like he usually does but a little
grumpier than normal and Saturn you kind
of asks them like you know I know when a
mind is burdened what's on what's on
your mind right what are you thinking
and at the end of the day like he kind
of holds off in having a conversation
but she kind of pushes in prods and he
says fun right it doesn't have to be
like this all you have to do is take
whatever it is that you want and then we
can end this here there's no need for
some great big ceremony none of this is
a necessity you're playing a game you're
being awfully Cavalier with all of our
lives for your own entertainment now for
Saturday's part she's in her rights to
do this right the conflict between
krakowa and the conflict between oracco
happen to come upon her doorstep and
then that's the nature of the beast when
two people are fighting and their fight
takes them into somebody's house they
don't get to dictate how the person who
owns that house allows them to fight
they fall under the rules of the person
inside that house right a man doesn't
walk into another man's home and start
telling him what's what it's just the
way it is right and so because their
conflicts leader than this point she's
the one that gets to call and gets to
call the rules right so that's just kind
of the way that goes and the response
she really gives here is I said exactly
what I meant right death is the great
change everything dies right one of you
guys are going to die here and
everything's going to change after if
anything I'm just curious what it is
that's going to happen and the response
of Wolverine is those are some famous
last words pops's Claws and stabs
saturnin
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are picking back up again with ten of
swords and in this one we are starting
with the beginning of the of the great
big huge the great big huge event right
the tournament right there could be a
huge battle but before we do we pick up
in the aftermath of Wolverine killing
saturnine right we saw that at the end
of the last video that Wolverine popped
his claws had enough of all of her
nonsense and just impaled that girl and
yeah following that Wolverine doomed the
world they basically killed the world
that we're told this in a couple
different ways the first one isn't a bit
of a kind of opening prologue of all the
different things that are going on in
the immediate aftermath and the second
is what we're actually shown here right
so what we're told is that what ended up
happening is that with the death of
saturnin that basically all hell began
to break loose right the external gate
was was essentially closed uh that
arguments kind of went about the quiet
Council in terms of what they were going
to do what they were owed to other world
with regards to the death of saturnin
right the quiet Council again is the
council that governs krakowa so at this
point they're kind of cut off from uh
from other world but the the
conversations were exceedingly short and
the reason why was because the external
gate immediately broke open and when it
did all the armies of Morocco came
pouring out led by the four horsemen of
apocalypse led by apocalypse's kit that
they basically managed to find a way to
control amen and in turn control all the
forces the all the amithy forces so all
those demons and they just kept pouring
out the difference here is that while
the X-Men do have the ability to
resurrect the dead it takes time to do
that whereas the forces of arako had the
forces of Amit and so they just
basically had this endless this horde of
monsters that literally poured into
krakowa and then the rest of the world
and that ten thousand it was it was
something like ten thousand or thousands
of of X-Men of mutants basically died
before a call for help could even be
made now when the call for help went out
that you ended up seeing like The
Avengers The Fantastic Four the entire
host of Asgard who all came in response
to that the other thing that the the
forces of arako did is they detonated
what was essentially a telepathic mind
bomb which literally ripped through the
mutant's higher brain function so
anybody who was telepathic dead anybody
with higher level thinking was
essentially wiped out right the forces
of Asgard the forces of the Avengers the
forces of the Fantastic Four were all
destroyed by the forces of oracco and so
what you end up picking up here is just
this entire Place laid waste right New
York the world itself completely
conquered right the home of Doctor
Strange right the sanctum sanctorum
totally destroyed Doctor Strange's
lifeless body thrown out of the window
right so for the most part it's all
completely been conquered and the only
person who is left to witness all of
this right the the beheading of
apocalypse him being drawn in quarter
the fall of the world was Wolverine who
was quite literally crucified right just
kind of stuck up on this this great big
huge platform and left there but then
he's immediately or at least eventually
met by the arrival of saturnin and what
we find out is this is a gift that
saturnin is giving him this is her
basically telling him this is what will
happen if you fail right if you if you
were to successfully kill me this is
what would happen if your team loses the
tournament this is what happens if you
fail to win this to Def to hold back the
forces of krakowa this is the faith that
awaits your world everything will fall
and everything will burn now under
normal circumstances I will say it was
it on the surface it seemed a little bit
disappointing that it was all just kind
of a ruse I expected it to be I didn't
actually expect Saturday to fall this
early it would have been a pretty
interesting scenario if she had but it's
also been established well in the
beginning of X of sorts that she's the
one that's kind of maintaining the piece
here if she wasn't there then everything
would just kind of break loose but I
think it's also kind of cool that it was
shown in in sort of a dream state right
because what it shows us is how dire the
circumstances are because there was
probably a part of you and I know there
was a part of me that was reading this
and it's like okay but even if cocoa
lost how badly could they really lose
right I mean you've got like Franklin
Richards and you've got like all these
powerful characters could they really
actually lose here and the answer is yes
they could lose everything the entire or
the entirety of Earth could fall right
everybody would die every superhero
across the world and all the mutants
would all be totally destroyed by the
forces of a Rocco this I think was a
genius idea by Jerry Dugan because it
shows us how dire things would get if it
didn't work and so in response to that
wolf range is kind of like okay right
like after seeing this he does it
grudgingly but he's like okay like I get
what's actually happening here I get how
extreme things are now of course this
leads to Wolverine being served as Sushi
Cipher of course eats a bit of it and
then Wolverine immediately picks up some
things wrong and that the sushi was
poisoned and so when that happens he's
just like somebody poisoned my appetizer
right like who in the heck did this now
eventually you know Cipher kind of comes
to through a combination of iska cutting
a hole in his throat right I mean iska
is a woman that could never lose the
other thing is that you end up having
the white sword right the guy that can
basically resurrect his 1 000 soldiers
or his 100 soldiers every morning right
so he can basically Resurrect The Dead
more or less ah who who shows up here
and actually ends up healing Cipher
right because we've known for a while
that his power is the ability to heal
but the other thing about this and this
was kind of cool is white sword is
wildly honor bound right he's hugely
honor bound because he literally says
here like poison is is the weapon of a
craven right the weapon of a coward
poison those that you don't think you
can beat what kind of honor is there in
that right what kind of honor is there
in this whole thing so he's like I the
white sword will not be party to
cowardice and so that's why he ends up
healing Cipher and so it's it's kind of
nuts because Wolverine makes this demand
of saturnin this is getting ridiculous
it's getting out of hand they're
literally sabotaging us send us back to
herkoa and call the tournament off and
just lock them in their own realm but
the response to saturnin is do you
really intend to Forfeit after the gift
that I just gave you after I showed you
what would happen if you lost now while
all that's going on right while all this
madness is happening you end up having
apocalypse and Genesis husband and wife
and the the the parents of these four
horsemen who are just kind of looking on
and apocalypse is like I see you did
well with the children and she's like I
did my best
right because remember
it is a measure of Honor that goes into
it but honor is not the most important
thing the most important thing is being
able to pass testing because apocalypse
probably looks at Cipher and sees him as
somebody who has measured testing and
found wanting because if that was the
case he wouldn't just arbitrarily take
part in something somebody else had he
would have investigated it right he
would have been like I mean is it is
this trustworthy or you know he would
have asked questions the fact that he
couldn't survive simply being poisoned
and had to be saved by somebody else
shows how weak Cipher is in the eyes of
apocalypse and so it's kind of one of
these funny things because you end up
having Brian Braddock and Betsy Braddock
who approached saturnin and while
everybody's arguing it's this kind of
discussion one of the funny things this
storm is like pointing their finger at
Jim Jasper is like if you had anything
to do with this I'll probably end up
beating you up and it's like okay but
like no you wouldn't either right I mean
like he would just turn you into a
teacup and step on you that's probably
what would happen but saturnin kind of
snaps your fingers and basically mutes
everybody right so they can't hear
anybody else talking and Brian Braddock
kind of makes this request and saying
look like I request that you set aside
their claim they they like basically
declare their efforts as forfeit they
literally poisoned one of us right and
so because of that they are effectively
cheating and Saturday's initial response
is like what you're asking is fair right
what you're asking is fair and it is
reasonable hadn't Wolverine not tried to
kill me right had he not tried to kill
me I would have granted your request I
would have given you what you wanted
because they cheated but turnabouts fair
play if Wolverine can try to attack me
it's fair for them to try to poison you
right I mean Wolverine made the first
move he opened the door for that and so
if I let you stay I have to let them
stay as well you can't have the rules
this kind of favor you because it's just
more convenient that way as it was kind
of nuts because following that you
almost kind of see a little bit of
coming together of the various
characters who are here that you see one
of the horsemen talking to Wolverine and
and she's like I never would have
attacked the magistrates like damn
that's that's pretty ballsy and
wolfram's response is I just want to get
my people home and she's like the
singular desire of every Brave Soldier
right so they're kind of finding a
little bit of Common Ground here and
that's what's interesting because I
wouldn't I wouldn't be surprised if by
the end of all this there's actually a
kind of mutual respect that exists
between the forces of apocalypse and the
forces of Krakow but that's what's
interesting about this right and that's
that's why stories like this are so
intriguing now what they end up doing is
of course serving the next cert next uh
next course and it's like everybody take
your seats and they end up presenting
these uh these scarabs stuff with the
hearts of of pollinate from the rivers
of wuhave cooks to Perfection and a
reduction of the greatest wines from
sevileth now I'm not even gonna lie to
you guys I might actually eat some of
that I know it's scarab beetles and
that's gross it's it's probably worth
trying vitamins probably it's probably
worth giving a bit of a taste to now I
say that because I'm a foodie right and
what if it tasted like chicken I'm just
saying you know I'm just saying right
what if it tasted like chicken here's
the real question would you eat this
that's the real question to ask but with
this the scare being served one of the
horsemen is just kind of like why would
you serve me this this sacred Scarab why
why would you serve me the secret the
sacred beetle
and it's kind of a funny reaction right
because he takes his helmet off for a
second and like is literally powered by
a sacred beetle right so this is Jaime
Reyes it's not but it'd be cool if it
was uh but you end up having Wolverine
who just like eats it in this place it's
just like we can't let the food go to
waste you know and that's what this a
lot of this stuff is it's all basically
kind of a ceremonial thing and so
following that you get to like the main
course itself right and the main course
is and it's really the second time it's
being served in that the house of Fallen
banners it's the great horned beast and
the funny thing here is it looks like an
enormous stake right I mean it's just
cut into huge sections and the white
sword is just kind of like you know I
never eat you're right I'm beyond hunger
I don't really need anything but for
this I will make an exception
and Wolverine's like yeah man it's
delicious this is absolutely amazing but
you kind of see these moments when the
two of them kind of come together or I'm
sorry when these these guys sort of come
together and find some common ground now
one of the funny things that takes place
here is when young cable actually ends
up talking to apocalypse and his wife
now young Cable's familiar with
apocalypse that's one of the the wonky
things about his character imagine that
like your teenage self imagine like if
you're if you're a person who's 30 years
old imagine your teenage self basically
kills your 30 year old self and then
takes takes the place of your 30 year
old self in the modern day that's
basically what cable did right just kind
of take that concept and move it forward
by like 3000 years and that's basically
what it is right this is just teenage
cable who killed his adult self and then
is operating here in the modern day a
lot of the experiences that adult cable
had teenage cable simply hasn't had yet
and that's why you see this this sort of
conversation where where he's talking to
where he sits down between Genesis and
apocalypse and he's like man this must
be really weird for you guys and the
responsive apocalypse is weird is a
human word right it's used to describe a
reality that human in mind simply just
cannot grasp that's all this concept
basically is right in time you will
understand that when you have more
experience now this kind of pisses off
cable a little bit and the reason why is
because everybody understands that he's
a teenage version of his older self but
everybody here was also familiar with
adult cable and they all know that adult
cable just kind of had years of
experience and wisdom that nobody else
really that his younger self just
doesn't have and that's kind of the bane
of his existence right like well you'll
understand when you're older right
that's basically what he's being told
universally by everybody right you'll
understand when you're older you'll
understand when you have more experience
and it's it's kind of a true statement
right it's very much a true statement
because older cable brought a kind of
wisdom to the various characters who
were here that this guy just can't do
following that you have this this this
hilarious and amazing situation where
cable approaches iska right and he's
like your power is that you cannot be
beaten right she's like yep I never have
been beaten and I never will be beaten
he's like that's so cool can you show me
your power and she's like you'll witness
it tomorrow and then you have magic who
shows up and it's just like but like if
we're all gonna be dead tomorrow like
let's see it now man let's see it right
now so they start putting your power on
display and literally start having her
do things where like she like they put
her through all these tests and so it's
like they have all these glasses that
are kind of turned like upside down and
stuff like that like she literally fixes
them all like they they have this thing
where they they literally put like a
little thing under a cup and she can't
see what it is and they're like where is
it and she's like it's right there like
literally every single game of luck
basically she wins right like every
single circumstance where she's not
supposed to know things she just
inherently does because that's how her
powers work she isn't it's impossible
for her to lose and so she is and this
is kind of a comment that's made by by
Magic what does she wear to fight Domino
because their powers are very much in
line with each other Domino is a
character who can bend luck to her favor
right so if Domino decided to go play
the lottery she would win right she
would just happen to go to the right
place to buy the right lottery ticket to
play the right numbers and then she
would come out on top that's just kind
of how Domino's Powers work she's Guided
by it right it kind of guides her
decision making with iska it very much
seems to be the same way now I would
surmise that because of how involved
iska's powers are and because of the
fact that she operates on a much higher
level in a more grandiose scale right so
fighting massive battles turning entire
tides of conflict different things like
that I would say her power is far more
nuanced and much much stronger for lack
of a better word than Domino's powers
are right so she's basically a far more
capable version of domino whether that's
true or not I don't know because if a
person who can't lose fights a person
who can bend luck to their side then it
almost kind of seems like an Unstoppable
Force meeting an immovable object who
wins in that circumstance or does
everything just explode
that's kind of the question to ask here
but from there you actually end up
switching back over to one of the
horsemen again who's having a
conversation with red root and this
conversation between the two of them is
really interesting right this Horsemen
is kind of looking at iska and they're
looking at cable and they're looking at
Magic and it's like these guys are just
so weak right like they're so weak and
they're so soft but then like red root
kind of chimes in and says but I can't
help but wonder and the response to the
Horseman's like what I mean they're
coddled right they're unfit and red root
says perhaps but these mutants were
grown on a world that's better than ours
so one what if they have a strength that
we just haven't seen yet right we wear
our strength on Our Sleeve we wear our
hearts on our sleep we make sure
everybody around us knows how strong and
capable we are but if these individuals
were raised in a world where they don't
have to display that all the time but
they're every bit as strong and capable
as we are then what if we're approaching
this with arrogance what if we're
approaching this with overconfidence if
we are that'll be our undoing like we
readily display that we're exceedingly
strong they hide it right so like it's
kind of a crazy thing because it's like
that could very well work against us and
the response to this Horseman is set
those thoughts aside right like look at
them they are inherently weak they are
not on the same level that we are and
that's entirely true the benefit of
Apocalypse is for Horsemen is that they
know nothing but war in chaos they know
nothing but conflict they were born and
bred in that and so if you're a person
that knows nothing but war and Chaos all
the time then of course you would
approach a situation or approach a
person that doesn't readily act the same
way you do and see a kind of weakness
because where they see kindness they see
weakness right that's just kind of the
way that works because it's just not
inherently necessary to their survival
in the place that they were from
kindness is what got you killed and so
from there you basically end up picking
up where the tournament actually
starting right it actually begins and
saturnin kind of gathers together all of
the different cards and says okay right
you have all dined well but now you must
return to your Chambers and sleep well
for tomorrow your minds and bodies will
be pushed to the absolute limit as you
compete for your Nations and the first
fight that we get here is Betsy Braddock
Captain Britain versus iska the
unbeatable
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with X of Swords we're on part
technically I think this is part 14. I
know we combined combine two parts
together so I think we're officially one
behind uh what the official numbering is
but it doesn't really matter uh we're
still going in order for those of you
guys who are looking to catch up you'll
find the playlist down in the
description so you're not you don't feel
like you're kind of left out and because
I know we're covering a lot of stories
right now so a lot of you guys may feel
a little bit lost uh check out the
playlist down in the description and
that will give you everything you need
to get caught up on the X-Men so uh what
we end up doing here is we pick up with
the official start of the tournament
right the official start of the duel
between krakowa and El Rocco and this
initially starts out with Jubilee
wrestling alongside shogo right shogo
being a dragon that was once human
informed and all that kind of stuff
anyway it's kind of like her
adopted kid more or less but the idea is
that in the middle of taking this nap
she suddenly met by a kind of telepathic
message that essentially tells her like
there's not a whole lot of time here but
in case you don't hear back from me just
know that things kind of went bad right
but I also care about you now this of
course this message is coming directly
from from Betsy Braddock right the new
Captain Britain kind of a funny thing
here and I don't think he was given an
official designation until recently but
Brian Braddock because he doesn't really
wield The Amulet of right instead and
now he's using this sort of Might uh
he's basically Captain Avalon that's
really how that works now but the idea
is that of course this kind of
telepathic communication is cut off now
Jubilee says if I don't hear back from
you by noon like I'll come over there
right I'll come over there and find out
what's going on now of course the reason
why this message was cut off is because
Betsy Braddock was interrupted you know
talking to Jubilee by iska the
unbeatable and so it's one of these
funny little things because iska has
this kind of conversation where she
talks to her and says hey like you have
the nine of Swords right like that's an
ill Omen and it's kind of like you know
when we get out there uh you know it's
not too late for you to quit right it's
not too late for you to like give up if
that's what you choose to do and the
response of Betsy Brad is like that's
not gonna happen right I'm not gonna
quit like I'm not gonna give up and
iska's whole idea is like you shouldn't
embarrass yourself out there right like
I mean that doesn't need to happen like
just give up now while everything's okay
now keep in mind this is not iska being
mind and being friendly it's her
basically taunting Betsy Braddock right
like you can't win against me so the
best thing for you to do is to give up
right is to just quit and it's one of
these things where she kind of says like
of course it's not gonna happen and her
response is I'm just giving you some
advice right unbeatable is not just a
name and and the funny thing is that
when Betsy asks iska like your sword's
called Mercy right she's like don't get
excited that one is just a name right so
when we get out there I'm not stopping
against you like I'm not holding back
I'm gonna kill you right because keep in
mind this whole tournament is for Keeps
right this is this is a fight to the
death that's what every single one of
these battles is and so what we end up
doing is picking up with the official
start of the tournament with a handful
of people from Otherworld here now on
the surface it kind of looks like man
there's like nobody here right like
nobody cares about this tournament the
reality of this is that it's being held
in such a way two are as reminiscent of
tournaments back during the era of of
like the arcade not really the Dark Ages
but like Knights and kings and so on and
so forth that's how these kind of
tournaments were held right they were
relatively small get-togethers different
things like that they weren't huge it
wasn't like the Roman coliseums where
you would have thousands of people who
were there all lining the stands they
were never really that big I guess
Hollywood's kind of made it look like it
was that big but they were never really
all that large in the first place the
other thing here is that Ryan Braddock
looks like the Burger King guy from
those creepy Burger King commercials I
just want to throw that out there that
just needs to be said I am 100 confident
in stating here that was the intention
because he is kind of a creep and he is
a king and he loves Burgers so I guess
it's only a matter of time before they
made him look like the Burger King but
having said that once iska and and Betsy
brought it come out here right on the
side of the cocoa it's like come on
Betsy you got this you got this right
but notice apocalypse he's just kind of
watching this whole thing go down
because he's kind of like okay it's
Betsy Braddock versus iska the
unbeatable what's the likelihood she can
actually win here and then once the
fight starts right like you have
apocalypse it kind of chimes in and says
you know where where Captain Britain's
like man she's got this in the bag the
response of of Apocalypse is well I've
learned not to underestimate the the
heart and and try like to trust in the
heart and the passion of young people
but understand Betsy Braddock is not
that old right I mean she's not she's
not been around as a fighter for a very
long time she was a telepath she was an
X-Man sure she has the powers or the
ability she had when she was quantum for
a little while when she switched bodies
with that Japanese ninja but iska has
been alive for centuries her skills have
been honed for centuries this is a girl
that does not have the ability to lose
and has also been fighting with a sword
for longer than most all of you have
been alive right the only person here
that I would say has been alive longer
than iska or anywhere close to however
long isk has been alive is apocalypse
everybody else here every single x man
every single every single person from
herkoa has been alive that long right
seemingly the blink of an eye and all of
iska's lifespan and so when that happens
once the fight kicks off things go kind
of Bonkers right because you have Betsy
Braddock who's sort of intimidating a
little bit and saying you can't lose
that just means you never learned how to
win a fight or never never learned how
to fight anybody at all and this is like
okay cool let me prove you wrong she
literally attacks and shatters the
swords of Betsy Braddock which in turn
shatters Betsy Braddock herself the
whole fight is over that fast like it
was literally two hits right it was
Betsy Braddock hitting isca and then
iska hitting Betsy Braddock and then
Betsy Braddock was destroyed just that
fast and so from there Saturday steps in
and says the fight really over that fast
that kind of sucks like I mean I was
expecting it to be a little bit longer
than that because apparently she ended
up showing up here late now a lot of you
guys are gonna look at that and say that
kind of sucks that the fight is over
that fast right there should have been
more to it than that that's gonna be a
common theme not because of the fact
that Jonathan Hickman is cheating us out
of a story but because there's actually
some pretty nefarious stuff going on
here and we'll find out more of what
that looks like here in a little bit but
from here if we switch over to Doug
Ramsey right over to Cipher and his card
gets drawn which means he's supposed to
be ready to fight but the response of
saturnin is like you know this little
party that we're having it's definitely
going to be a challenge and your friend
here better get used to learning how to
speak every language and he better learn
how to do it fast and the reason why is
because he's kind of LED Away by a
handful by like three gorgeous girls now
I don't understand this about Cipher
right he's literally being led Away by
gorgeous girls and he's like hey let go
of me where are you taking me guys hell
not me man if like if I were a single
man and I was being led Away by three
gorgeous girls I'd be like yes ladies
take me but at the same time they also
ended up taking one of the one of the
fighters from Morocco's side and so were
they where you initially have like storm
maybe a couple people who interject and
say like we have to do something the
responsible Wolverine after that Vision
that he saw because I had a lot of a
couple of you guys asking this question
um nothing that Wolverine saw actually
came to fruition it was a glimpse of
what could happen if he actually did
kill saturnin or if krakowa lost the
tournament right so it's just kind of a
glimpse there uh so again it was all
basically in his head but you end up
having you know Stormer kind of
challenges that Wolverine's like no like
we are not going to turn against the
rules if we win this we have to win
legit right anything other than that and
we will it'll lead to the ruin of all
and so these girls are kind of kind of
lead Cipher away
they lead this this other this other
chick away and then from there they take
him into a kind of tent of sorts and
it's kind of nuts because Ryan Braddock
looks to apocalypse and he was like like
you had me worried that Betsy Braddock
would be humiliated not destroyed and
the responsive apocalypse says are you
really that stupid we came here at a
tournament that's literally designed to
to determine the fate of our of our
dimensions and this is obviously a fight
to the death did you really believe that
nobody was gonna die did you really
believe that was gonna happen Brian
Braddock are you really that dumb like
it's kind of funny right it's kind of
hilarious but he's like I don't know why
you ever thought this journey would be
without sacrifice right some of us will
return home change some of us will not
return home at all now this is an
important thing to understand here
because remember with Betsy Braddock
basically being destroyed more or less
that means if they try to resurrect her
in krakowa then she'll come back a
different version of herself right this
is this is one of the things that I
mentioned when they previously
introduced this at the very beginning of
extra swords this is a way for Marvel to
soft reboot right and that's what we see
happening a lot right over the years of
Marvel Comics those of you guys who you
don't really get that over the years of
Marvel Comics their way of rebooting was
totally different from DC's DC would not
really soft reboot characters they would
hard reboot right they would do event
like Crisis on infinite Earth they would
do something like like Infinite Crisis
or New 52 which honestly crisis on
infinite Earths and The New 52 are the
only times that DC really hard rebooted
their entire landscape uh but what
you'll get after those are mini crises
right so you've got crisis unoffended
Earth and then you got zero hour then
you got Infinite Crisis and you got
final crisis those were designed to
basically fix plot threads that had been
left over after the events of uh of
Christ's infinite Earth you also get
stories like blackest day brightest
Knight and the Green Lantern Mythos that
was a soft reboot right you get these
small little things that are done here
and there in DC to kind of bring small
things back or change characters or
something along those lines in Marvel
that's all they do Marvel never hard
reboots right Marvel's never had an
instance in the history of their
publication line when it was like you
know marvel number zero or you know
Spider-Man number zero and this guy
number zero Iron Man number zero and
Captain America number zero and it was
just a line wide reboot that's never
happened I think it's a problem that's
never happened but that's never actually
happened instead what Marvel does is
stuff like this right so if Marvel if
Jonathan Hickman wants to rework you
know rebecci Brown if he looked at her
character and he says okay over the
years she's kind of grown stagnant and
her history has been really weird and
really shuffled and has kind of been a
hassle to follow because it has right is
anybody let me tell you something man
anybody who knows anything about the
publication history or even the just the
in-universe history of Betsy Braddock
will tell you it's a hassle right it's
an absolute nightmare to understand that
uh but if Hickman sits down and looks at
that and says yeah we should rework
Betsy Braddock this is the way they do
it right she dies here in other world
which means that they can't bring her
back the way she was when they resurrect
her it'll just be some random version
from of herself from across the the
Multiverse which means whatever version
we get is gonna more or less be a soft
rebooted character she's gonna have a
whole new history and all that kind of
stuff like she's gonna have to learn to
probably reintegrate herself back into
the X-Men things are going to be
different we might even get kind of a
little bit of history of her own
Universe along the way but whatever it
is she's gonna come out different and
she was before the only exception of
that is if she Somehow reconstituted
Here the way she was and nothing's
changed at all right but if she stays
dead and they resurrect her in kakawa
then it'll be a soft reboot of her
character right so just kind of
something to keep in mind now where
Douglas Ramsay is Led away right this
other person from arako this led away is
a woman called Bae the blood moon and
the idea behind this is that bay has a
set of powers that are almost identical
to the powers of Black Bolt of the
Inhumans right then that what she can do
is she can basically release something
called a doom note and this is
essentially just a giant concussive
force of energy that comes out of her
mouth in the form of her voice but what
she's learned is that over over time
it's not necessarily just like Black
Bolt right in the sense that when Black
Bolt speaks he's got a quasi-sonic
screen so we cannot talk and not scream
at the same time the only way for him to
do that is to like transition his
Essence to a different realm or for
Doctor Strange to create some kind of
pocket place where he can talk and his
powers are neutralized or something
along those lines but if he's just
walking down the street on Earth or
traveling anywhere within the normal
Universe in in the main Marvel Universe
if he talks he's gonna kill somebody
with with uh with Bae what she learned
is she has that power but she can also
talk at the same time so she can Channel
at any point in time so think of it like
a vocal version of cyclops's optic blast
when he's wearing his optic visor right
that he can look around when he has his
optic visor on but he can also Channel
his powers if he wants to at the same
time that's kind of how that works and
so because of this uh one of the things
that goes on with this Doom note is that
it works a little uniquely with Doug
Ramsey in the sense that Doug has the
ability to understand any language but
he can't understand hers because hers is
a language that doesn't exist within the
main Marvel Universe but I mean I guess
it does but a Rocco has been so far
removed from anything in the main Marvel
Universe it's a language nobody in the
universe has ever encountered before and
so because of that the Doom note itself
the the kind of power in the voice of
they desires to be understood right it
wants to be it wants somebody to to hear
it and to understand what it's saying
but the the words she speaks are not
really a true language and she cannot it
cannot really be translated and so it's
almost kind of like this vocal slash
Linguistics version of a an immovable
Force meeting an Unstoppable object that
kind of a thing it's it's kind of crazy
you know with this this little bit of a
thing here but the whole reason why
they're being brought together is really
kind of brought to bear when you have uh
Magic visiting Doug and the two of them
kind of start talking about what's going
on and he's like I have no idea what's
happening like what's what's going on
right here she's like well Brian's
pretty inconsolable he's pretty pissed
off and everybody else is as well uh
they're just kind of you know mingling
with the the Iraqi people a little bit
more but no one really feels friendly
towards iska right they're all kind of
pissed off at her because she killed
Betsy but uh as the as the doors open
and they start to step in that Doug
realizes oh my God like Bay's not gonna
kill me in a tournament she's gonna
marry me like it's literally a marriage
that's kind of been assembled here now
here's the funny thing about this right
teeny Howard plays this fast and loose
it's just kind of like okay like Doug's
like all right cool I'm gonna get
married now here's the thing man right
like you see the two of them standing
next to each other this is a big woman
right and not terms of not in terms of
girth but just in terms of like physical
size she's like what maybe like two
heads taller than than Douglas Ramsey
right she's got maybe like foot on him
all right let me tell you something
Cipher she's gonna make a man out of you
man okay
yes she is she's gonna man she's gonna
make a meal out of him you better be
ready but uh but nonetheless this is
kind of a crazy thing because the time
comes for them to like make their dials
and he's like I mean I didn't prepare
any vows and Saturday's like well then
you better prepare him you better you
better do a quick fast and in a hurry
and he actually makes these pretty
amazing vows on the fly right he says
bathe the blood moon right this is a
little absurd because I don't know
anything about you but you're gonna be
my wife so I swear to uphold my vow to
you for the duration of this Challenger
whatever right however long it goes
after and I'll always be grateful that
we got to do this instead of sword fight
because I'm not really ready to die
they're not bad vows right now in
response to that uh bay offers her vows
which are really good as well right she
says like when the Grim fog of Bloodshed
overtakes us the Beloved is the beacon
that returns us to our better selves
love is a failed heat that cannot be
broken I will love you with the force of
the wave that crashes the shore like the
current that swallows the sand this is
kind of cool it's pretty interesting and
so he's kind of like I mean I don't
really understand thing you said this is
really really fascinating and then she
pure she pulls back the veil and uh and
Doug's like man she's super hot right so
he just immediately swept up and how
gorgeous this girl is and so from there
like in the middle of this wedding fire
just goes everywhere
fire just gets sprayed everywhere and
here comes Jubilee riding shogo and
everybody's like Jubilee what are you
doing like what are you doing here like
you're flying in here with a dragon like
here comes a clue train Jubilee the last
stop is you this is not a good idea
you should not do this you should not
fly in here with a dragon and start
breathing fire everywhere but you
believe he's like well I told Brad Betsy
riding but I didn't hear from her by 12
then I'd come over here and see what's
going on now here's the crazy thing
about this is keep in mind shogo's
dragon fire in other world has the
ability to melt that reality right he
can literally destroy the physical
principles of that reality and so when
when you have you know Wolverine who's
kind of like hey man it's kind of cool
this dragon's coming here and he's gonna
burn the place down the response of
Apocalypse is no that's not cool at all
Wolverine that is not by any means a
cool thing I mean maybe a little bit
maybe it's like a little bit cool but
it's not as cool as you're making it out
to be right because this Dragon will
destroy the reality in which we live
right and we will all perish along with
it right so killing us is the least of
what this dragon and can do it's kind of
a cool little a cool little thing there
now while all that's going on uh Cipher
is kind of like okay like he's talking
about he's like are you gonna go out
there she's and she doesn't really say
anything right he's like are you really
gonna go out there and you're really
gonna you're really gonna do all this
they're like I mean if you do here's the
thing like don't kill like don't kill
the dragon the dragon's cool it's like a
little baby right like the dragon's cool
like don't kill the dragon she
immediately turns around and kisses him
right so here's here's what I'm gonna
BET right I'm gonna bet this here and
I'll tell you what if I'm wrong I will
give out three Rob core Rings right I
will give three Rob core rings for free
which by the way feel you guys were
asking uh we're gonna start selling them
I'll make an announcement later but I'll
give out three Rob core rings for free
what I'm willing to bet here is that the
time's going to come when it's time for
Cipher to fight and she's gonna fight in
his stead and every single match that he
has that I doubt the two of them are
actually going to have to fight each
other and if they do have to fight each
other she'll sacrifice her life for him
and then Cipher will basically be the
one who wins the tournament he'll come
out on top and he'll be the one that
says saves Krakow I will bet that I will
bet that's exactly what happens I don't
know if it is but I will bet that's what
happens now the cool thing is that once
Saturday shows up here and realizes
what's going on she's pissed right she's
she's eight kinds of pissed off right
just she's she's mad as hell when she
comes she comes walking out here and
she's like no like this is not gonna fly
and it's one of the well no pun intended
but it's one of those things where like
she almost intends to destroy it but
then you have Wolverine who kind of
chimes in like that baby's Gonna Hurt
storm right and that's when Saturn he
realizes oh that's right it's a baby so
she uses her magic and then manipulates
the mind of of shogo in order to bring
him to her and bring him under her spell
right she also kind of just dissipates
his dragon fire so it can't really
destroy anything inside of uh anything
inside of other world but it's one of
these things where she makes this
comment where she was like you know it's
lucky that I'm in a good mood today
right because if if you had actually
flown Jubilee here I would have killed
her in front of everybody but I would
have killed her in front of every single
person here and so it's a little bit a
little bit nuts because from there you
know once everything kind of settles
down that it's like okay she's like I'm
in a good mood but I got my drinks we
got a wedding we have cake right one
point for each side right like one point
for each person and that's where it ends
so in the first match right the first
day of this battle which I won't even
lie this story kind of went off the
rails and the first day of this battle
uh Betsy Braddock died in two hits and
oh really just with one hit and Cypher
got married to a chick he doesn't know
so yeah that's kind of where we are now
here's a crazy thing about this it's
only gonna get crazier
what's going on guys this is Rob and for
the first time in recorded Marvel
history Wolverine meets mad Jim Jaspers
and this is hugely exciting I am so
excited about this because it's just a
cool moment right it's just a cool part
of this story but before we get into
that we pick up with the next part of
our battle right of our ex of Swords
event and this picks up and the holy
Republic of Fae which leads to the
floating Kingdom of Roma Regina kind of
passing through a portal to access
another location and what we have here
is Ileana Rasputin facing off against
hoggerpod right one of the forces of
oracco kind of a weird name it's a
little bit interesting guys basically
like a giant crocodile thing but the
funny thing about this is that with
Ileana Rasputin she is prodigious with a
sword not to mention when you add in the
various magical effects that come with
the soul sword along with her ability to
use magic as well this fight is a
non-starter right it's done the problem
is this is not a sword fight this is an
arm wrestling contest
saturnine changes it on a whim she's
like nope ah this is a contest of arms
so hands clasp shoulder Square elbows
and the pocket pin to win and it's like
arm wrestling seriously and of course
hogger POG decimates Iliana Rasputin now
one of the things we're going to find
out here and one of the things you're
going to see over the course of this is
that there's something pretty sketchy
going on right we kind of talked about
that in a previous video something's
pretty seem pretty sketchy but with
pograpog to Victor here the score now
stands at a Rocco 3 cocoa one and so at
that point we switch over to a place
called The blight spoke and this is a
wholly new environment that was created
by Jonathan Hickman in this story the
funny thing about this is that this is a
an interesting scenario an interesting
situation historically speaking when it
comes to alternate realities in Marvel
Comics every universe that dies is
reborn again and it really kind of
follows the function that that universe
is destroyed and then kind of coalesced
into a new universe so it doesn't really
matter how it happens so if you were to
take like the main Marvel Universe why
we were to say this universe reaches its
inevitable heat death which is to say
the point at which it's going to die you
have the big bang where everything
expands outwards and you have the a
crunch where it all condenses back into
a singular you know singular point of
energy and it explodes in a big bang and
is reborn again but say for example
somebody like Jean Gray as the dark
Phoenix lost her mind and wiped out the
whole universe the universe would be
singularly destroyed and that would be
the end of it right that would be the
end of that Universe in previous years
it was always assumed that the end of
that of that Universe would lead to it
being reborn right it would just somehow
come back into existence again what
Jonathan Hickman does is he says Nope
that doesn't happen when a universe is
destroyed prematurely in that form it
goes to a place called The blight spoke
and the blight spoke is is kind of a
composite of just dead realities right
where they all just sort of coalesce
into a singular land mass right so if
you were to say like the United States
for example is a combination of dead
realities then like Chicago is like
there's like an alternate reality and
New York is an alternate reality and
California is an alternate reality right
like all these cities and all these
states are all just alternate realities
but they all kind of share this this
sort of energy that's called the blight
energy in the sense that when a person's
there it quite literally drains off your
life Essence right it'll kill you over
time that's the reason why Wolverine and
the Summoner are brought here is because
they are they have a healing factor and
they are for the most part
indestructible that's kind of what
they're referred to but the reason why
this fight is so intriguing is because
where Wolverine finally calls out
Summoner and Summoner responds to him
that what they end up doing is literally
falling through different realities and
as they fall through these different
realities they experience a kind of
reality shift so in one Universe they're
just covered in bugs right bugs
basically took over this entire universe
and killed everything in existence in
Another Universe it's more old school in
Another Universe you have a scenario
where Summoner is actually kind of like
an old man Logan type character there's
one Universe where they're all kind of
futuristic right there's it all kind of
bounces and it changes around one where
like the mini angled ones conquered
everything right one where they're chess
pieces it's just any possibility that
exists there's a universe for it and
that's one of the things that Marvel
never really explored and in fact a lot
of you guys had a really cool idea for a
video uh that I will make that I'm
actually gonna make on that not really a
video per se but a comic book series
then I'm actually gonna I'm gonna talk
about that I'm gonna make a separate
video on that because I think it's
really really cool but at the end of the
day when it's all said and done uh
Wolverine manages to get the upper hand
on Summoner stabs him through the eye
and kills him and he loses and the
reason why is because saturnin comes
along and says Nope this was a fight to
the death Summoner fought to the death
you fought to stay alive therefore you
lose as you guys can tell the odds are
basically stacked against krakowa that
what it looks like is happening is
saturnin is basically cooking the books
in order to ensure that krakowa loses
now from that point we switch over to
the Crooked market and this is basically
just the bar that's run by Jim Jaspers
where you have Wolverine and you have
storms sharing a drink and what we end
up getting is basically a card presented
to them whereby it's a drinking contest
right they both have to drink and
whoever lasts the longest ends up
winning the benefit of this is that it's
a guaranteed victory for Cocoa it's a
guaranteed point but the funny thing is
that Jim Jaspers kind of has this quick
little conversation with Wolverine where
he talks about the blightness is bloody
magnificent is what he refers to it as
right this drink called the blightness
is one of the most Exquisite things that
either of them will ever put into their
mouths now I can't reiterate this enough
this is the first time this ever
happened right um to me let me tell you
something man to me this is exciting
this is hugely exciting Jim Jaspers
meeting the X-Men for the very first
time this only matters if you're a fan
of Jim Jasper's but this guy could end
these guys like that and in fact Jim
Jaspers will actually show off his
powers here in a little while here and I
think uh in the next video that would
get Hoshi goes to show off his powers
you'll see what the kind of stuff Jim
Jasper is capable of but one of the fan
theories and this is a genius idea that
one of you guys came out with one of the
theories that you guys came up with on
Discord is you said what if Jim Jasper's
is actually the one controlling
everything and saturnin is just doing
what he tells her to he's the one who's
actually in control of this and saturnin
is a servant to him what if that's the
case and I was like that's kinda nuts
because that's entirely possible right I
mean this guy is a universal shaper he
can control any space that he's in it's
ridiculous how powerful Jim Jaspers is
and a whim he could turn these guys into
ants right Wolverine and end storm he
could break them down and just turn them
into stone he could turn them into each
other but he could turn Wolverine in a
storm and storm into Wolverine he could
he could do any number of things right
this guy There's No Limit whatever it is
he can imagine doing it becomes reality
right that's just how powerful this guy
is but what we also end up finding out
is that as they're drinking this
Wolverine starts to get drunk and that
doesn't happen because remember
Wolverine's healing Factor keeps him
from getting drunk now that is alcohol
in the main Marvel Universe this may be
an entirely different breed or at least
that seemed to be the case until we find
a find out the horsemen death who's
currently a part of the uh of the iraqan
forces working for Morocco he presents
an artifact to Jim Jaspers and we end up
finding out what death did is he bribed
Jaspers to poison the drink of Wolverine
and storm to make them drunk not only
that as they start to get drunk that
depicts up with the next battle between
the forces of Krakow and so the forces
of Morocco that works akoa got a battle
amongst themselves a Rocco got a battle
amongst themselves as well and the logic
behind this according to saturnin is
that they all originated from a singular
land mass the landmass of okara and so
in essence it is basically groups that
are part of the same community all
fighting against each other right that's
the stance of saturnin and so for oracco
to fight krakowa they're basically
fighting themselves and that's why these
these kind of battles among the krakowan
and arakim forces as part of this
tournament is taking place but what you
end up getting here is basically solemn
facing off against the horsemen of war
and this is a personal Vendetta because
remember solemn had killed the husband
of Horsemen War at some point in the
past but the caveat to this is that if
you guys recall solemn and Wolverine met
each other and a bargain was struck
between the two that they were both
tasked with tracking down the muramasa
blade and that Solomon gotten his hands
on both and so he was only going to
relinquish his blade to Wolverine if
Wolverine would strike a deal and that
deal is brought into full Fray when
Wolverine is teleported away from the
storm and brought to this conflict drunk
as a skunk and the bargain that was
struck was that at some point in time at
a time of his choosing Wolverine would
fight in the place of solemn and he's
calling in this he's calling in this
favor now the funny thing about this is
that it doesn't really seem to matter
that in reality here that because solemn
has adamantium's skin that wouldn't
really make any difference War would not
be able to defeat Solomon so something
else seems to be going on here what that
is we don't fully know but with
Wolverine being here and being
absolutely drunk he also reveals that
he's the one who killed Summoner
Summoner of course being the son of
Horsemen war and so solemn killed her
husband Wolverine killed her son The
Horseman war is pissed and so because of
that
she starts losing it right starts going
off on Wolverine full blast now
Wolverine real you know it kind of
experiences this this cut and one of the
things that saturnin really a comment
she really kind of makes here and what's
really interesting is she draws a great
a great concept here she says you've
become Reckless you become reckless in
the face of the fact that one you can
heal from anything and two the
resurrection protocols can always bring
you back you've become exceedingly
Cavalier you don't know what it's like
to fight to the death anymore and and
that really I would I would say is a
great analysis That's The Winning Edge
the X-Men have lost since they've been
on krakowa and the funny thing is that
the idea of creating kakura or bringing
all the X-Men to that island in the
first place by Xavier was to create a
place where the X-Men and really in
population could have their own
government could have their own their
own Island Mass but in the more macro
scale right the much larger scale here
it was all done from what we saw during
house and powers of 10 right house of X
powers of 10 uh that we basically saw
this situation where a war was going to
happen at some point in the future and
so all of it seemed to have been done
for the purpose of making the X-Men
stronger and even apocalypse himself in
the early days when his family and his
Horsemen ended up inside arako he made
the promise to his wife that he would
make the world stronger but in giving
people the ability to always come back
from the dead you make them weaker
because suddenly none of the battles
that they're in matter because their
philosophy is well no matter what
happens I'll always come back so even if
it's not a conscious thought it's a
subconscious thought even if I die I'll
come back and so they lose the edge that
they get when they play for keeps and
that's the point that saturnin makes
that you become Reckless you've become
complacent The Wolverine of yesteryear
would have slaughtered War right would
have absolutely ripped through War this
battle would have been a non-starter the
horsemen War would have died so fast but
over the over the years his healing
Factor all those things playing in war
brains lost his Edge and it's really
kind of a way of Jonathan Hickman
criticizing the publishing history of
Marvel and saying you've taken away from
the thrill of ferocity of one of the
most ferocious characters in Marvel
because over time he always just comes
back and so what we end up finding out
is a caveat from having that drink at
Jim Jasper's bar as part of the bargain
that was struck between Jim Jaspers and
the horsemen of death is that when they
were poisoned it took their powers
Wolverine has lost his healing Factor he
doesn't have the ability to come back
from the dead and so you end up having a
war who manages to pin him get the upper
hand and then go for the killing blow
but of course she cannot actually kill
him because he has an adamantium
skeleton but in the end the win is given
directly to his Horseman War because
Wolverine cuts off her hand but the
problem with Wolverine cutting off her
hand is that's not a killing blow
because Horsemen War got the killing
blow even though Wolverine didn't
actually die the victory goes to a Rocco
now I'm of the mind that a Saturday
Neymar playing Fair the victory would
have gone to Wolverine because he can't
be killed and because he can't be killed
there's no way it can be a fight to the
death right so that would have been the
end of it but again it's one of these
things where it looks like Saturn name
is intentionally cheating in order to
make sure the forces of arako come out
on top and if that's true then the
question becomes why
okay so we are continuing on with swords
of X and in this video we're picking up
with X-Force yes we are in the
continuation of this battle so the
swords of X event it gets a little wonky
here right like I always thought it
would actually be a duel with swords
like strictly with swords apparently
that's not really the case well at the
start of this whole thing the score is
Oracle 5 kokoa 3 we end up having a
Rocco getting getting a six point then
they get a seventh point then they get
an eighth point and gracoa just keeps
falling behind and it's these various
weird and wonky competitions right like
who can push a boulder up a hill or like
who can who can basically out swim
monsters and survive uh you have an
eating contest where you get foods from
the Crooked world there's a dance off
which apparently uh Scyther does
amazingly well right he absolutely
crushes it so he gets a point um there
it's like Penrose steps that they have
to navigate through uh they have to put
together a puzzle right so like krakowa
gets a win on that because I guess the
forces of arako aren't the sharpest tool
in the shed well either way it was had
to be done because it was forces from
the same side but then like you end up
having a Runway walk-off which I don't
even know that was really like I guess
it is a contest in terms of like I don't
I don't know I don't really do runways I
know there's a show about runways anyway
uh storm crushes it right and a lot of
that's attributed to the fact that it's
because you might be drunk but like
consistently across the board they're
just kind of like these wonky and Goofy
competitions right they're just sort of
weird and and almost nonsensical the
other thing about this is that you end
up having Brian Braddock who's still
kind of continuing on he's within the
Crooked Market itself and kind of
continuing on and a little still a
little brushed about the fact that like
Betsy Braddock's basically dead right
and so you end up having him met by
saturnin and saturnin who again refers
to him as Captain Britain he basically
disregards that says I'm not Captain
Britain don't call me that she
ultimately says like the title is yours
and if you won't come around to being
Captain Britain willingly then Fury will
work right and she basically seems to
have the furies at her back now one of
the other things that goes on here and
it's something that I'm not 100 sure I'm
on the fence about is you have Jim
Jasper's encountering Captain Britain
again but Captain Britain doesn't really
seem to give any indication that he
knows who he is and it would have been a
cool little a cool little nod um in the
sense that you you would have Jim
Jasper's like it's good to see you again
cat I'm sorry things ended so weird last
time but you know you tried to kill me
and everything it would have been cool
to see that right just kind of a little
reference to the Crooked World from back
in the day it may be that it's just kind
of like you know marvel doesn't really
care or Hickman doesn't really care I
don't really know but it would have been
a cool little nod you know to see
because I love that story so much and I
love the character of Jim Jasper's
because he's just so broken and
overpowered you end up having this thing
where it's basically a race between red
root and Brian Braddock and red root is
of course more or less a shrub and she's
super slow but in the midst of all this
when when uh when magic Jasper says like
you'll be able to find the Finish Line
around here somewhere right you look
hard enough you can find anything in a
crooked Market including a Finish Line
once the gunfire goes off and Brian
Braddock starts running he's immediately
set upon by these Furies right these
Furies all immediately go after him
because it's basically saturnin working
against the working against Brian
Braddock and the forces of krakowa uh
because Brian raddick won't basically
won't be her guy right he just won't go
with her right he just refuses to bend
the knee so to speak and to you know be
the whatever it is that saturnin wants
out of him right a concubine I don't I
don't really know regardless red root
basically begins a process of just kind
of of passing him up and of course she's
kind of walking and walking but she ends
up bumping into this table and shatters
a crystal that happens to land at the
foot of Jim Jasper's and he just kind of
says everything has a cost of the market
right everything now of course she
continues on blissfully unaware of
what's happening and then ultimately
crosses the finish line which is
something like five feet away from them
now saturnin of course does this just
for the sake of giving the point to a
Rocco right so she's again like the the
contest is basically rigged but where
Brian Braddock is basically subdued Jim
Jaspers starts talking to red root and
says okay so like now there's the matter
of your debt and she's like what are you
talking about he's like you shattered a
crystal right this rare Crystal Idol of
bamboo right crafted from the salt of an
umbagonian princess's tears I don't
really know what that is but he's
basically like it was priceless right
everything here has a price if you break
something that's priceless you have to
deal with it accordingly and so
basically with the whole process being
done and saturnin sending the furies
away which is also a little bit of
disappointment that Brian Braddock
doesn't recognize who they are then in
turn Jim Jaspers uses his ability to
manipulate reality and shrinks red root
down and encases her in glass and leaves
her there like she's literally just kind
of stuck there forevermore uh seemingly
never to be able to escape and so with
that being the case you in turn have a
Saturday who basically says like you
have done Untold damage to the Crooked
market right I mean there's no
calculating how much damage you've done
here everything here is irreplaceable
right so if red root was shrunk down for
what she did God only knows what Jim
Jasper is going to do to you unless of
course you ask for my help if you ask
for my help then Jim Jaspers won't do
anything to you now whether or not
that's what he did we're not given a
definitive answer to instead what we end
up doing is switching over to these two
interesting scenarios that go on in
terms of part of this contest right the
first one comes in the form of magic
where she has to answer a riddle if she
gets the answer right uh then of course
she gets a point if she gets it wrong
then she loses right so the the riddle
is uh a white rabbit pulled out of a
blacktop hat and a spell cast by a
wizard and the Very life force of
saturnin what am I and she basically
says that's an easy one magic and it's
spelled Magik and she's wrong
she got that one wrong because she's an
idiot uh but with with Wolverine and uh
and and white sword it's a little bit
different they have to stand in front of
a mirror and they have to observe the
faces of all the people they've killed
the first one to look away loses the
first one to Blink loses Wolverine
actually ends up crying and ends up
blinking now this is designed to kind of
compare these two characters between
each other the white sword relishes and
loves the idea of battle and doesn't
really care much about the people that
he's taking out with Wolverine it's a
wholly different Beast because the
people that he's lost in some ways have
actually been a result of his own
actions specifically his wife dying the
son of Dakin right she died partially
because of Wolverine's actions himself
right he kind of led to that situation
taking place the people that Sabretooth
killed over the course of his life like
his actions inevitably seem to lead to
that and so because of that like he you
know a lot of the losses he sustained
have been a defining part of his
character but also crushed him at the
same time and so that's why Wolverine
ends up being the first to Blink
Wolverine loses so the score now stands
or Rocco 15 kurkoa 5 right they're
getting absolutely destined and things
only really seem to get worse right they
have these things called The Rock Sirens
of uh of clevermore that nobody that
almost no one can really resist their
call and Gorgon goes running up on it
right just gets naked starts taking his
clothes off like yeah man me and the
Rocks we're gonna get it on and then
from there you end up switching over to
Merlin who presents a challenge to the
horsemen war and to Captain Britain and
says your challenge is to kill the
kitten that's your task and like War
just immediately goes to kill it and
Brian Braddock's like no you can't kill
that kitten that by that in that moment
is basically him acquiescing it's
showing he wouldn't do it krakowa loses
right so arako 17 cocoa 5. and that's
kind of how these things continue but
then you pick up with storm and you pick
up with the horsemen of death and the
two of them you know storm really kind
of seems to come too after having been
Intoxicated by having been drunk and
they brought to the realm of severalith
right kind of like this this realm of
vampires and so on and the contest is
again basically a fight to the death and
where Storm initially says no we need to
postpone this because something's wrong
with me whatever it was that I had at
that bar of uh of Jim Jasper's I'm
effectively drunk now the response of
death is I mean no but I mean you can
but if you do then you'll have to
Forfeit and that's when she realizes he
intentionally did this to her like he
got her drunk sacked her power and now
like she's gonna have to fight in
traditional hand-to-hand combat the
thing about this though is storm is no
slouch and she's also one of the best
fighters in Marvel not the best best
where she's not like in the top five or
probably even the top ten but she's a
really really really good fighter and
able to hold her own and as she's
fighting this conflict against uh
against death she gets the upper hand
and actually destroys his sword in the
process and so in response to that death
removes his helmet and he basically
intends to use the death stare now the
death stare is basically those
individuals who look upon it effectively
die right if you if you glance if you
look at that look into his face his
stare will kill you hence the reason why
he was given the name death but he's not
immune to his own powers he's just
highly resistant to them and this is
this comes in the form that when he
emits the death stare and that kind of
substance comes out and intends to kill
storm she reflects it back at him using
her sword because her sword is pristine
and it's basically a mirror and so it
basically kind of you know incapacitates
him for moment she punches the sword
through his chest and kills a Horsemen
of death this of course leads to all the
vampires basically tearing him apart and
the point goes to Cocoa so at this point
right now because the storm make managed
to bounce back but they're still losing
terribly right now the score is 17 arako
six to krakowa no earthly clue how in
the world they could possibly make that
up
okay uh so before we start this video
two things one for those of you guys who
are curious about the selling of Rob
core rings that was not a one-off I'm
gonna sell them again but I'm gonna I'm
gonna do it again I'm not gonna leave
you guys just once two those Rings sold
out in two hours now I have not found a
way on Etsy to show that the Rings were
sold out right as soon as a single ring
type showed uh sold out then it was it
like Etsy automatically delisted it
right so that's why some of you guys
went to the store and you didn't see
anything there because they were all
sold out right but in two hours they
were all gone for those of you guys who
did buy Rob core Rings you should be
able to go on to Etsy and you should see
the status of your order uh they should
all be on their way the only exception
is we got an order from a guy in Norway
and we had a little bit of a convocation
it was on our end it was not anything
you did wrong uh but we fixed it and
everything's all sorted out so uh we
will order more Rob core rings and we
will send out more Rob core rings and I
will place more up for sale so keep your
ears open uh and I will let you guys
know when you can buy them so uh anyway
on to the video
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are picking up with the conclusion of X
of Swords I hope you guys had a great
Thanksgiving week I know I did I
definitely needed that break I
absolutely needed that break uh I was
going nuts just I think we've been
probably doing this non-stop for about
two years without really taking a break
uh so I needed one
but uh but we are picking back up with
the conclusion of uh of X of Swords
right we're wrapping this whole thing up
and initially I thought about doing each
of these individuals separately but I
think at this point we can just kind of
do all the videos together and just sort
of call it a day I do want to touch on
the hellions because we're gonna kind of
skip over this the hellions was a
totally unnecessary story I'm not really
sure why it was included in this in the
first place the only real takeaway of
those of you guys who remember the only
real thing going on with the hellions is
that their goal was to get into other
world and steal the swords of Rocco so
they couldn't even compete in the first
place which would basically seem to
nullify the entire tournament now as we
saw not all the fights were being done
with swords really only those who needed
swords would be disqualified but then
Saturday probably would have changed
things what ended up happening with the
hellions however is that it was revealed
that Sinister simply wanted to just
steal jeans of mutants that existed out
there and once the other hellions found
out Sinister managed to achieve his goal
to a degree and then came back to uh the
the krakowan gate back into the main
Marvel universe so to speak and then
pretty much killed all the hellions and
that was basically it right so there's a
little bit going on there but not a
whole lot certainly nothing that works
worth you know that warrants us covering
the entirety of the story but what's
really important here is we pick up with
the next part of the tournament which
takes place in cable and this is done by
virtue of cable having to face off
against Bay now of course Bay is the
wife of Doug Ramsey right she's the wife
of Cypher and so Cable's kind of
watching all this on or I guess he's
really kind of engaging in this knowing
that he's probably gonna have to kill
the wife of Doug Ramsey and in that
moment of hesitation Bay gets the upper
hand now here's the big difference
because Cable says things like you know
if I had been who I was before then this
probably never would have been a problem
in the first place and that's true one
of the things for those of you guys who
aren't really familiar here and I've
heard people ask this why is cable so
young Marvel introduced a retcon by
basically having Cable's younger self
kill his older self and then take his
place as kind of like the new cable it
was a way for Marvel to kind of
reinvigorate the character a little bit
I kind of feel like it was unnecessary
the older cable had a lot of great
storytelling going on and I think his
situations you know he would have been a
lot more interesting useful and would
have made the stories a lot more
intriguing but such as it is we ended up
getting younger cable instead now the
problem with the younger cable is he's
not quite battle hardened yet not in the
same way that his older self is and he's
right when he says if this was his older
self he would have killed Bae like that
but it would have spin over like he
would have just killed her in an instant
and would have been like cool like we
get the point done and he would have
like watched Doug Ramsey cry and he
probably would have comforted him and
said hey man sorry but like you know the
entire Kingdom of krakowa and the entire
like our entire Earth is more important
than your wife right so with that being
the case with bade getting the upper
hand uh with cable kind of hesitating
for a moment but vade basically topples
him she breaks his arm and then she goes
for the killing blow and Doug jumps in
and asks her to stop right he says like
stop like you've basically won uh this
was supposed to be finished right and
Saturday had kind of declared this was
going to be a battle to the death but it
was going to be a fight to the actual
death itself but then she kind of kind
of relinquishes here and says but some
deaths are of the spirit right so in the
end I award the point to arako kokoa is
now down basically it's 18 to six right
they're down by 12 points this is a
pretty huge number to have to catch up
now from there you end up picking up
with cable contacting Jean Gray and
cyclops directly which is something that
he's not really supposed to be doing
right using his telepathy and managing
to reach to them but the fact that he
was able to do this to essentially use
his telepathic powers to reach across
dimensional barriers and contact Gene
and a cyclops that's a huge thing right
this is really more of an act of
desperation but for people who create
like respect threads right like the
power of the telepathy of of uh the
power of like cables telepathy or like
Gene Grace telepathy or something like
that this is one of those examples that
we'll use right they'll just say like
was able to use this telepathy across
dimensional barriers right or something
along those lines right that's where
this kind of stuff comes from but the
reality of this is cable looks at the
situation and says it's dire and we're
probably going to lose right like we're
down 18 to six the deck basically seems
to be stacked against us like she wants
us to lose I'm not really sure why you
know I'm not really sure what's going on
here I'm going to stay here and fight as
much as I can but like tell Esme right
of the stepper coupe the kind of
girlfriend of cable tell her I love her
right I mean that's kind of where this
is now saturnin steps in and cuts off
his connection and that's when Cyclops
and Jean are like okay we we need to do
something now we'll get back to them
here in a second what we're going to do
here is we're going to focus on Gorgon
right he's the next fight now Gorgon is
one of these guys and the reason why he
wears a bandana around his head is that
if he takes it off and he looks at you
you'll turn to Stone but he's being made
to fight off a face off against White's
sword but facing off against white sword
is not just fighting him it's fighting
his 100 soldiers and so he says like
you'll fight me after you fight all of
them and so he says like once you get
through all 100 of these guys then we'll
battle and so he says number one right
this first guy comes running in gets
like gets his head chopped off and an
instant then it's two and three those
guys get taken down then it's four five
and six right those guys get turned to
stone and one of them manages to make it
through and gouge out the eyes of Gorgon
so his primary power is basically gone
here and so now he's basically just
fighting using his own prodigious
martial arts skill but then it's now you
have to fight all the rest of the other
ones right you have to fight seemingly
all of them and so what ends up
happening is that Gorgon actually takes
out something like 13 of of like the
white swords Champions which moves the
number right so it actually gives them a
lead right because each one of these
individuals that he kills counts as a
point so it kind of seems like Saturn
needs more or less balancing the numbers
and so now her cocoa is ahead 19-8 and
that's when the horsemen step in and say
in this right because if he kills all
100 of your soldiers it's gonna move
them up they're gonna be 106 to 18.
they're going to crush us right like
there's not gonna be any chance for us
to win like the tournament will
basically be over right I mean there's
not enough you know not enough opponents
for us to face off against to finish
this right to come out on top now so
that's when white sword steps in and
says okay fine then the battle will be
between the two of us and it's one of
these things where Gorgon knows he's not
going to win right like he knows he
cannot come out on top here there's no
possible way for that to happen and the
white sword says I'm going to kill you
and then I will bring you into my bring
you into my Army and the responsive
organ is not a chance right I walk my
own path whatever happens to me after
this whatever death awaits me whatever
comes next in this afterlife it will not
be as one of your henchmen right and
that's when uh when white swords like
okay fine if you don't want to be then
you don't have to be right and then just
Punch The Sword through his chest and
basically kills him now there's two cool
things that come out of this the first
is apocalypse kind of commenting and
saying this is how a mutant dies if
you're going to die you die on your own
terms you die in saying I'm not going to
be a subject to anybody else right you
die with what you perceive to be your
own honor the other thing that comes out
of this is that gorgen was I wouldn't
necessarily say an essential member of
the X-Men roster but somebody who
probably could do with a bit of
revamping and the reason why is because
gorkans never really had major roles in
Marvel for quite some time this is kind
of an exciting moment because it could
be one of these things where Marvel just
never chooses to bring him back right
Pikmin just kind of writes him out and
he's gone or it could be they bring him
back and he's totally changed because
remember he died here in other world
which means if they resurrect him he'll
come back in any number of different
versions of himself from across the
Multiverse we don't know which version
it'll be so he could come back with
better Powers he could come back weaker
he could come back as just some old sage
wise man who never fights he could come
back in a wide array of different forms
but with the Gorgon having been
destroyed right now the score is
currently even a Rocco 19 Croco at 19
and I need you to keep that in mind hold
that in in your mind as as long as you
can because this will become important
because this leads into the final battle
between apocalypse and his wife who's
donning the helmet of annihilation one
of the things that happens here is an
apocalypse challenges his wife to face
him off as herself right to basically
not use the the power of annihilation or
any of that stuff so it's really just
kind of husband and wife dueling each
other but the other thing that comes out
of this is really more with uh with Jean
Gray and cyclops that with the message
they receive from cable and the fact
that things seem so dire they go to the
quiet Council right and they say like we
need to go do this like we need to go
rescue our son and the quiet Castle's in
a in a bit of a predicament right
because the biggest issue they face is
that when they ask Cyclops what is it
you intend to do Cyclops response is
twofold one I'm gonna assemble a Strike
Team this Strike team is it's gonna be a
smash and grab job right we're just
gonna break into the end of the world
we're gonna pass in there we're gonna
grab our X-Men and we're gonna come back
we need you to hold the gate open until
until we do now the issue with with the
Kauai Castle is but what if you die over
there right if you die over there
there'd be no way for us to know right
because saturnin is cut off any
telepathic Communications to that realm
so it's not like we can maintain a
telepathic lifeline and know whether or
not you survived and say oh my God
Cyclops and Gene and all the X-Men are
dead all right close the portal so they
so nobody can get in they just kind of
have to wait and see but if they die
over there and there's no way of knowing
they died they could potentially just be
holding the portal open for an invasion
that they didn't know was coming so they
could literally sow their own in the
other part of this is that Jean Gray and
cyclops are part of the quiet Council
and so it'd basically be taking away
from from their number now anybody who's
familiar with governmental positions
knows that usually individuals who hold
positions of government are not afforded
the opportunity of putting their life on
the line leaders don't have that luxury
right because somebody has to govern
it's the responsibility you take on and
so what this means is that while sock
hops and Gene are simply just going to
go right it's one of these things where
it's like we're gonna find a way to
leave so you're gonna have to like lock
us up or something then in turn earned
the quiet Council now that they're met
with the the idea that uh that like
Nightcrawler wants to go their concern
is okay then what do we do now right
what do we do in this instance where the
cry council could potentially lose three
or four of their number do we suddenly
just hope they come back in one piece do
we ensure the governing body can
function the way that it's supposed to
because remember everybody here has a
role to play so the government has to
continue on and so in order to to
basically satisfy this need to answer
this question a vote is given and the
vote is is given in two forms the first
vote is if you guys pass through that
gate and you die and there's no way for
us to know that you die and we could be
holding the gate open for enemies then
that means we have to close the gate
right we can't take the chance that if
you perish there and we don't know that
we allow all the enemies to come
flooding in right any chance that we
have of closing the gate will be gone at
that point and so what they say is you
know the first vote is doobie close the
gate after the forces of the Strike Team
Jean Gray Cyclops after they all pass
through the answer is yes right we
closed the game the second concern is
what do we do about you guys leaving the
Kauai Council and potentially dying so
do we just kind of hope that you guys
make it back in one piece do we put the
entire government on hold in order to
you know in order to find out whether
you made it back never knowing how long
it could take you to get back that if
something went wrong and you guys were
stuck there for decades and decades are
you guys just grew old there and died
because you could never find a way back
do we just kind of allow the quiet
counsel to function in its own way
without you guys there or do we fill
your seats and when they vote the answer
is if you go you lose your spot right
we're going to replace you with somebody
else but at the end of the day Gene and
cyclops don't care their stances we
don't care like we are going right we're
gonna go with this you know apocalypse
is already there right it may very well
be that he might perish that that
there's individuals who are out there
that are supposed to be on the council
that could very well die and so because
of that you know they've already lost so
many of their number they effectively
vote if Jean Gray and cyclops pass
through this gate and they take this
Strike team and they go to other world
for this Mission then they give up their
position on the Clyde Council and Jean
Gray and cyclops say we're okay with
that and they leave right they basically
walk away because it's one of these
things where they say if if the cry
council is the government of krakowa
then the X-Men are its Heroes and of
what use are heroes who refuse to fight
Maya Legions is to the mutant population
my allegiance is to the people and if we
as the Kauai Council are going to sit
and just rest on our Laurels effectively
you know and just kind of not really do
anything in the face of such Dire
Straits then of what use are we right
and so Cyclops and Gene basically leave
and where you would expect some measure
of condemnation from the quiet Council
instead it's really Magneto insight and
in Xavier who were just like that's
exactly how we raised you that's exactly
what you what we're supposed to do and
it's one of these things where we we can
kind of assume a lot of the reasons why
some of these folks don't leave could
very well be tied to like Maura
McTaggart and the idea that like does
this kind of Greater game that was
established during the house and powers
of X and the sense that like if they
perish everything would come to an end
it really seems to point to the idea
that Jean Gray and cyclops are not
really that essential to the Future
survival of the X-Men either that or
this is something that has to happen
right but regardless of the situation
they basically pass through and they go
into into other world itself and so
picking back off with apocalypse and his
wife things are interesting here this is
kind of cool it's this really really
amazing moment where the wife of
Apocalypse gets the upper hand right
Genesis gets the upper hand on him and
and like destroys his sword and says
okay like I give you one last kiss and
then I will hear your surrender and
welcome you back to your rightful place
by my side and then she and she like
when she destroys the sword she asks
like will you yield apocalypse here's
the thing to understand about apocalypse
right always outnumbered never outgunned
right apocalypse is not a guy who falls
easily right this is not a man who
yields and that's exactly that's exactly
what he says man Jonathan Hickman
Jonathan Jonathan
Jonathan Jonathan Hickman man man it's
it's man it's it's it's so it's like
it's like one of the coolest moments
because apocalypse is like I will not
yield not to fear Not To Doubt and not
to love where Genesis thought she had
the upper hand in four moves it's and
then she's done right that's the end of
Genesis like literally like just swipes
right through and that's that you know
like like and it's and it's nuts because
that's the thing man apocalypse men is
bad people man man she sleep on
apocalypse son like that's exactly what
it is and that's what makes it so crazy
is because with her basically being
defeated apocalypse is like I don't want
this right he looks at Saturday and he's
like I don't want this right I don't
want to kill my own wife I'm not in
favor of this now keep in mind the score
is still 19 to 19. whoever wins this
wins the contest and so with that Saturn
means like I don't really care what it
is that you want right like the
tournament Must Go On You must slay your
wife or be slayed by your wife for a
Victor to be determined here but in this
moment when apocalypse and saturnino are
having this conversation then suddenly
like genesis puts on the helmet of
annihilation completely heals herself
and is just like nothing is settled
right like I Annihilation am now in
total control here nothing is settled
right like this will go on and we will
fight now when that happens right like
when she Dons a helmet of annihilation
she calls in everyone like literally all
the forces of ameth just come pouring
into other one at this point it's just
like man the hell with the tournament
son like we're just gonna do this right
now like that's exactly what this is
right now the the different little fairy
people whatever they are the fish folk
of uh like the forces of of saturnine
right here little assistance AIDS
whatever they are they immediately run
and grab like the little uh like these
this this kind of box right that
contains all these little puzzle pieces
more or less and the idea is that when
saturnin puts this together it will
effectively give her an answer on what
her next move needs to be and what it is
that she that she needs to do in this
but without you know beyond saturnin
what's going on right now is all hell is
breaking loose Sun like all these forces
of amethyst are pouring in here and
you've got like six X-Men and Captain
Britain basically facing off against
them all doing everything they can now
where where ameth goes for the killing
blow against apocalypse and seemingly
he's just gonna let it happen right like
out of nowhere she's struck by lightning
right out of nowhere she's struck by
lightning enters storm right Storm's
like okay so she's only going to be
delayed for so long right like she's
only gonna be delayed for so long like
we've got our armies routed we have to
get out of here right like we have to
leave and the responsible apocalypse is
like not a chance man like no way we're
like there's no way I'm leading my wife
behind but at this point it's not even
The Stance of of apocalypse and what he
wants it's like like run run away live
to fight another day right like we can
get out of here we can get back to your
KOA yes I guess I mean the score is
currently tied we can figure this out
later right but like for right now we
need reinforcements or numbers or
something while that's going on they
actually ends up abandoning the forces
of arako grabs Doug Ramsay and just runs
right just like takes off running right
it's just like okay so like she snatches
up her husband right because you know
he's she's like hey you know I need to
make a man out of you before before
we're done so she snatches him up they
just go running and so all the X-Men
what's left in these guys are basically
just fighting to the point of exhaustion
they're just fighting like to this
moment to this point of exhaustion and
there's not a whole lot that they can do
here it's just like like at this point
you've got what you've got Captain
Britain you've got Wolverine you've got
apocalypse you got storm and you got
magic and that's it against this
virtually endless horde of all these
guys well then out of nowhere Here Comes
Jubilee right like here comes Jubilee
coming in with like all these fairy folk
right because she was just kind of
hanging out with him for a little while
I guess it's by no means like a like a
turn lace it's not like like the battle
has turned right I mean it's Jubilee
should create fireworks right she's like
you know
she creates fireworks right there's
really nothing going on there but at the
very least their numbers are temporarily
bolstered and it does give them a chance
to kind of survive this experience now
what you also end up having is Doug
Ramsey talking to Bae and saying look
like basically I love you right I mean
it's more or less what he said right
it's his decoration of love like I
absolutely love you but we cannot stay
here right we can't just run away from
my friends we have to go back we have to
help them survive like we have to make
sure that they live through all this
right we have to find a way to end this
tournament I can't just leave them alone
and so one of the things he kind of asks
her he's like you don't have to stay
here right you don't have to stay with
with oracco you can come back when this
is all said and done you can come back
to krakowa and you can live among us
right you can live at my place like
we're married right so I mean you know
it's it'll take a little bit of
decorating I mean it's a bachelor pad
you know it's a bachelor pad until like
a day ago when we got married you know
and happened out of nowhere and I wasn't
really expecting it but you know I mean
surprises happen in this game of life
you know I don't know what to tell you
so it's it's kind of a it's kind of a
cool little thing but like basically of
course Bay ends up traveling back you
know and so the the forces are marshaled
a little bit larger but still there's
not much they can do here the funny
thing about that is that when all this
begins to happen as all this is taking
place you know Annihilation you know
basically Genesis you know it's more or
less possessed by Annihilation now it's
like it's like we won right like we
basically won here this not necessarily
formal because I haven't killed
apocalypse but I'm going to but I'm
going to destroy this guy well then from
there we switch over to saturnin and as
saturnin is assembling this this puzzle
piece that's when she can she begins to
realize oh my God right she like she has
to reassemble the Captain Britain core
more so than that this this kind of
puzzle that seems to have existed before
before she ever took over was you know
it's a little ambiguous it all seems to
point to the idea of like the definitive
Captain Britain and the definitive
Captain Britain is Betsy Braddock right
like the fates have more or less
determined it's Betsy Bright Now when I
say the fates I don't mean some
individual out there who put this you
know box of of pieces here and then said
okay you know now Saturn in your in for
a surprise when you find out who the
first is supposed to be you know it's
just one of these things where it looks
like it's out of her control that's one
of the things about Otherworld is this
very very ambiguous right there's a lot
of talk about the fates and and how
things could unfold and you know how it
could end and whether or not things
would turn out the way that you hoped it
to it's one of those things a little
ambiguous but the big takeaway from all
this is the captain Britton Corps
completely gets reformed by saturnee
right she reforms the entire core and
the entire core comes responding like
they they come pouring in right they all
come flying in and it's like okay like
our numbers are bolstered like we have a
chance the fact that the Captain Britain
Corps is reformed is pretty cool right
we haven't seen them since the events of
the incursions when they were all killed
by the map makers and the beyonders
right so this is the first time that
we're seeing the Captain Britain Corps
fully reassembled now for for the forces
of annihilation as she continues
fighting and as a Captain Britain Corps
comes showing up they're not really
putting up a huge fight right there's
not really a whole lot doing here uh and
they're actually getting taken out quite
readily but what she says in response to
all this is like they summon an army
summon one of our own and she talks to
like War right she's like summon one of
our own so they summon all these just
helliest looking Creeds all these just
terrible looking monsters from the world
of like literally from from like
annihilation's Realm someone like all
these different huge monstrous beasts
and things like that like it's getting
kind of crazy right it's getting
absolutely Bonkers and it's one of these
things where you end up having Cyclops
and Gene who chime into magic now here's
here's the thing that happens man here's
the thing that here's the thing that
happens here's the thing that happens
man so she hits up hits some Cyclops and
Gene here let me show you something like
psychos and Gene hit up magic and they
say okay like you need to open a portal
for us right like we have our forces
here you need to open a portal and
they're like she's like okay like I was
wondering how long it would take for you
guys to get here right so slammed your
sword into the ground opens a portal and
when it when she does it brings in the
entire sword space station right this
whole sword space station when it opens
up everybody comes pouring out right so
you've got wind pool you've got dupe
you've got Gambit right you've got you
got all kinds of people here you've got
Quentin choir so you've got like this
huge mishmash of like all these Omega
level mutants and all that stuff like
it's it's like almost the entire forces
of krakowa like everybody who's
currently in X-Men comes pouring out
into this thing and all hell breaks
loose man let me tell you something let
me tell you something Jonathan man
Jonathan Jonathan John and Hickman man
man it's man it's it's man man they were
not prepared do the forces of amethyst
just just like the the dude they it is
an absolute Massacre right like it's an
absolute bloodbath so they start
summoning even more of their monsters
right like even more of their absolute
monsters they're like she's like summon
it all summon everything right bring
everything in here that you possibly can
so all these monsters start pouring in
here right like all these things just
start dumping in here the X-Men are all
like fighting for the like like fighting
for their lives man like it's it's it's
it's absolutely Bonkers and so from
there like like you have cable who's
kind of watching all this unfold and
he's just like he's like dude it doesn't
look like there's really a way for us to
win and Saturday's kind of talking to
him and she's like what card were you
dumb and he was like the fool and she's
like only a fool would really look at
this sword and believe that's all he's
really holding now remember back when
when Donovan I'm sorry when X of Swords
was going on remember back when they
were in the sword space station and the
whole sword space station was taken over
by those crazy looking monsters right
those crazy looking monsters that only
desire death and destruction right you
guys remember that and they managed to
push them all back through that portal
and locked them away in the realm of
death what ends up happening is Cable's
just like oh my God right like I totally
forgot about that this is why Jonathan
Hickman does this stuff because they've
got an army of forces they're just in
the in the thousands and thousands and
thousands that seemingly matched the
forces of a Rocco right or at least that
seems to be the case right that like
matched that huge Army the forces of
ameth like it's just waiting in the
wings all they have to do is just
unleash it right and so like cables like
get me to this get me to the ship right
get me to the sword ship Giving To That
device where all we have to do is unlock
it they're like okay so as soon as they
get in there and they literally unlock
that door all those forces come pouring
in like hell right like Iliana Rasputin
makes a portal so they all go flying
into that portal and they show up into
this realm and just start killing
everything they find right I mean if
anything it's like Lord of the Rings you
guys remember like that that Army of the
dead guys the ghost or whatever it is
but as soon as they show up like the
whole battle just turns right that's
exactly what happens there's this
amazing moment right where like one of
these these monster things are like
we've suffered in a dead realm for far
too long picked its bones examined it
fully now we seek a heartier meal and
like in ameth right Annihilation right
like this this chick for the the helmet
chick with the the wife of Apocalypse
she's like you want the full measure of
a world then come creature taste my
medal and feast on ameth and like just
annihilates this guy right like I love
the way that Jonathan Hickman does like
these one-liners like they're just so
ridiculously cool and so like from there
like where she goes to make this other
statement apocalypse grabs her right
let's like tackles her down to the
ground and rips the helmet off her face
right like rips rips the helmet of ameth
off the face of Genesis and remember the
helmet of ameth has its own its own mind
right it does its own thing you know
anybody who wears the helmet is
possessed by the helmet and so
apocalypse puts the helmet on everybody
he stops right everybody stops and it's
just like do holy cow it's just really
gonna happen right now is apocalypse
gonna put the helmet on and apocalypse
grabs it and sits it on its head and
like and and literally he's just like I
am remade right I am apocalypse you know
I am totally remade and an Annihilation
try like Anna tries to take over the
apocalypse right like Annihilation tries
to take over apocalypse and like and
initially it seems to be successful but
then like apocalypse Takes Over Control
right he takes over control of the
helmet and it's just like no like I am
apocalypse I'm not some servant to some
arbitrary object that exists out there
that some Demon entities in possession
of right like when you step into the
realm of apocalypse's fear of influence
you fall to the influence of Apocalypse
right I will not be controlled by
anybody and just totally dominates the
helmet now while all that's happening
and the way in which we know that
everything is going to turn is iska
turns against the forces of oracco and
that's when they realize we're not gonna
win right like literally her power is to
always win so as soon as she turn coach
then it's like okay then we've basically
lost here and that's what apocalypse
steps to saturnin and says can you hear
me and she says yes I can hear you and I
can see you and he says then fine I as
as a host of annihilation and the leader
of the forces of of the iroquo army I
Surrender and just gives up and that
gives the wind to krakowa right cocoa
went dude it's amazing man it's just
like dude that's so that's such a
ridiculously cool idea and this had her
name is like cool done let's do this
right so she goes flying in with with
the shogo dragon but whose dragon fire
member has the ability to melt Realms
and just like literally punches a hole
in this fabric of space which rips
through all the forces of an of ameth
right like it rips them all through and
even those those weird demonic looking
Force entity guys right like so so
they're all more or less out of the way
the demon the weird guys from the other
dimension they're all pulled back in the
forces of of Amoth are just kind of
waiting to find out what their orders
are going to be essentially like like
what do we do now and so essentially the
the helmet is is pulled off of
Apocalypse saturnin restructures it and
turns it into a staff which is actually
really really really cool and then from
there it's kind of like okay so like now
that this contest is basically done then
I want a show of good faith right I want
a show of good faith that you guys are
not going to wage war against each other
again and when the question is what's
this show of good faith she's like I
want a mutant from cocoa to go to arako
and I want a mutant from Morocco to go
to kokoa that's what I that's what I
require that's what I ask now what the
character with apocalypse uh basically
he ends up going with the orako forces
right he ends up joining arako now this
does not mean that Marvel's getting rid
of Apocalypse if anything they're
probably just kind of keeping him on the
back burner for a little while because
in reality this whole extra swords event
was a story about apocalypse right
that's basically all this was it was
just a story about apocalypse but when
the questions asked who basically speaks
for krakowa who from cocoa is going to
demand somebody from Morocco come to
their come to their location apocalypse
says as the only member really the the
highest ranking member of The Quiet
Council here I will speak for kirkoa and
the person that I choose from Morocco to
come to krakowa is the entire oracco
nation the entire Island itself right I
want the island of Morocco and that's
true remember Morocco is a sentient
Island and it was one half of cocoa when
they were okara like that's the whole
idea and they were split in the in the
sense of like all these forces showing
up in the first place and apocalypse was
basically the one that did it he's
reuniting the the island of of cocoa
with the Rocco recreating okara but he's
doing it at the sacrifice of himself he
is leading with his forces and it's one
of these cool things because what it
does is it transforms the character of
Apocalypse it takes him away from this
guy who's just like oh we're just gonna
destroy stuff and test the people who
are you know the most fit to make sure
they're they're actually fit you know
and just kind of be a dick from time to
time you know and and you know and the
transforming from like that guy into I
am basically sacrificing my place on the
quiet Council so I can be with my wife
and my kids right it makes him a tragic
hero and it's amazing it's absolutely
amazing that's why stories like this are
so cool because Jonathan Hickman is so
good at changing up the entirety of
characters and so what you get here is a
little bit of an epilogue and I'm not
going to spoil too much here because I
believe this is gonna go into what is it
though the reign of X and like and oh
okay I'll I'll throw this out there it
looks like Jim Jaspers is going to kind
of seize control right like it's going
to focus on Jim Jasper's kind of rising
to control and then who knows what's
gonna happen right who hasn't added
because here's something I want to make
clear to you guys saturnin was bound by
Magic right she's Bound by the limits of
magic so there's only so much you can do
there she's Bound by like the limits of
fate and all that kind of stuff when it
comes to other world there's all kinds
of tradition fade all pop and
Circumstance all that kind of stuff Jim
Jaspers is a crazy guy with the ability
to manipulate up to you know everything
up to and including the most reverse
right this guy is just a as on a whole
nother level right like Jim Jasper's is
ridiculous now like Jim Jasper's if he's
anything like the way he was before but
has more fine-tuned control over his
powers than they've probably been
expanded right and if they've been
expanded if Jim let me let me put it
this way if Jim Jasper's weakness that
he has to have a reality to manipulate
in order to you know be be in his
absolute Peak if that weakness is
removed Jim Jaspers is right after there
with like the Living Tribunal if it's if
that's removed I'm not saying it is but
if that's removed Jim Jaspers is well
beyond the Marquee of death and Matthew
Malloy and Protege and all those guys
he's right up there with a Living
Tribunal if not between the Living
Tribunal and the one above all right
there's no limit to what he can do
that's a big if and we don't even have
any idea what they're gonna do with this
character right so don't take this as an
absolute truth I'm not saying that it is
but it's kind of Bonkers right it's kind
of crazy because when when the dust
settles and everything saturnine really
kind of retakes her place as the
omniversal magistricts and she got
pretty much everything she wanted the
Reformation of the Captain Britain Corps
the one person she didn't get was Brian
Braddock you know she of course wanted
him more than anybody else but in
essence the entire omniversal
development court has been restored
she's back to being the Omniverse
magistrix and the Captain Britain Corps
has been returned that's one of the
reasons why I wanted to cover the uh the
original Mad Jim Jasper story all that
stuff is coming back right all that
stuff is basically back to the way it
was before so
what's going on guys this is Rob and man
let me tell you guys something okay
Inferno is here and here's the thing we
need to get caught up man all right so
here's what so this week we're just
gonna dump X-Men content I know I've
said that before we're actually going to
we're just we're gonna dump a ton of
X-Men stuff so that's that's something
to look forward to everybody on patreon
I apologize we're gonna postpone patreon
stuff because honestly we just don't
have enough time for it all uh we're
just we're gonna we're gonna get caught
up on the X-Men right we need to get
caught up on all this stuff because oh
Inferno is amazing okay so I'm I'm very
very excited for this after this was
done I think what we might do when we
have like all the stuff completed is
we're gonna do a full story from the
beginning of house and powers of X all
the way up to the end of Inferno right
this is the end of the three-part act
right this is this is where Hickman's
done he moves on he goes to three moons
three worlds whatever it is right and
just kind of calls it a deck I'm curious
to see how long this full story would be
I feel like it'd be like like over 24
hours
I have no idea that'd be the case or not
but what this does is this initially
opens up with the orcus forge right now
remember the orc is forged because it's
been a while since we talked about this
the orcus forge is the headquarters of
essentially orcas itself and orcas is a
coming together of a multi-faceted group
of people right like Advanced idea
mechanics Hydra just the government in
general right like just normal human
scientists all these people working
together for the purpose of what is in
effect destroying the human threat and
what this does is it focuses on what is
basically the X-Force team Wolverine
Domino uh kid Omega right Quentin choir
these guys are highly capable and as
they get in there they're immediately
met by the arrival of of nimrod right
now this is one of the most important
things about the character of nimrod we
talked about it before but it Bears
refreshing here right Nimrod has the
ability to analyze a mutant to know what
their powers are and then develop
basically counters to their powers so in
the case of domino domino has the
ability to bend probability to her favor
in a localized field so what does nimrod
do he says solution cluster bombs with
Quantum targeting which number in excess
of the combat area basically overwhelm
her powers to the point that there's no
conceivable means for her to escape and
ultimately it works one of these bombs
bonds itself to to Domino and she gets
blown to Pieces following that it goes
to quit inquire right kid Omega Nimrod
analyzes him mutant possesses Omega
Level telepathy as well as some
telekinetic ability Threat Level
enhanced processing cores at risk
solution rotates ionic Shields and phase
shift cores into secondary host then
disintegrate Target before he can
overcome defenses I.E Quintin choir can
dominate the minds of both man and
machine so basically create more minds
and he can dominate at any one
particular point in time and move so
fast that he can't react and that's
exactly what happens right like
literally Nimrod starts phasing through
his mind basically to the point that
quit inquire can't dominate it and then
while that happens create a second
version of himself to attack Quentin
choir from behind and then he says that
just leaves and then yes right Wolverine
the last man Left Right busting hit
busting out his adamantium claws tearing
a hole through uh through Nimrod and
then he's just easily incinerated by
those robots and then it's just stop
freeze it there and that's when you
basically pick up with orcas as these
guys are talking to each other right
you've got Dr Greger remember she's kind
of like the scientific person the one
that really seems to be the most
hell-bent on destroying the entirety of
the mutant population and then director
Devo who's the one that's kind of
running the whole thing and the question
director Devo asks is after 16 times
that they've come here and tried to
destroy us and Nimrod what have we
learned that's something to know the
X-Men have tried this 16 times and
they've done a variety of different
things they've they've brought in
different teams they launched a brood
Invasion remember Broods are basically
aliens from another dimension that
deposit their eggs in and then those
eggs essentially take over the host and
then create more brood and it doesn't
matter right Nimrod still takes them all
out every single time the X-Men launched
an attack against orcas they get
destroyed over and over and over again
and as they've analyzed this the one
thing that they've began to pick up on
when the questions asked again what have
we learned is it Dr Greger hypothesizes
that these are clones that these are
basically the same people who are being
sent here right because the bodies are
being taken and you've got multiple
versions of Wolverine now that's one
thing to know that orcas and the rest of
humanity don't know that the mutant
population has the ability to resurrect
themselves they don't know that they
don't know about the five the
resurrection Gardens all that kind of
stuff they don't know about any of that
kind of stuff right all they know is
that seemingly these are clones or
duplicates doppelgangers something like
that but somehow or another the X-Men
are able to duplicate themselves and
they've just been sending teams here the
second thing they've learned is that the
X-Men the strikes that they're engaging
in are basically the same which reveals
a huge Revelation here that while orcas
is advancing they're becoming more and
more capable they're quelling these
X-Men threats faster and faster every
single time they're launched the X-Men
threats always come in the same way
which means they don't remember remember
when they were here before and that's
when the the statements made by another
person and certainly saying no it's not
entirely they don't remember someone
remembers that's why they keep coming
here somebody keeps sending them here so
what you end up doing is you switch over
to more mctaggard right at the time that
she creates basically the cure for the
mutant race and when this cure is
created and she's basically thanking all
the other scientists here there's a
colossal explosion which is very very
similar to the one that we saw from Days
of Future Past back in the day basically
everybody's killed except for more
mctagrid and she's met by the arrival of
Mystique and Destiny now this is a huge
thing because this is actually the third
life of Maura McTaggart if you guys
recall from house and powers of X that
Mormon taggard has lived multiple lives
now the way that that was explained to
us by Jonathan Hickman is that at most
she has 11 lives and that she could just
kind of continue living those lives
basically forever and ever and ever and
ever right she's like 11 in at the time
that we go from house and powers of X
into the actual launching of dawn of X
right everything that's happened in over
the course of the X-Men mytho so far has
been the 11th life of more mctagon I'm
pretty sure it's the 11th one but so the
question has to be asked here how long
can this go on for if that's her mutant
power is to basically be resurrected and
always come back but remember everything
from her past life then how can she how
could she possibly be destroyed and
that's one of the things that Destiny
talks about now remember Destiny's dead
right so this obviously takes place
before Destiny's death but she's dead at
the moment right now so she's not really
a threat that you have to worry about
but in this life that she has when she's
talking to Maura McTaggart and she says
like you would think there'd be no way
to kill you you would think there'd be
no way to destroy you but understand
I've seen your future I know what can
happen and I know how to destroy you and
so what you end up learning here is that
the only way to kill more McTaggart and
she stays Dead Forever is to kill her
before her powers manifest if you kill
her one second after her powers develop
she'll reincarnate right like a fraction
of a second after her powers uh emerge
she'll reincarnate but if you kill her
when she's like eight years old she'll
just be dead she'll never be able to
come back but the question that Destiny
has here is that in looking at more
McTaggart what she sees is that
seemingly Maura McTaggart will always do
this now this is the other side of the
equation that we never saw during house
and powers of X for whatever reason that
was never really given to us more
McTaggart had always worked on creating
like a mutant cure she had these
different escapades happening over these
different realities but we didn't know
why it is that she suddenly went from a
person who was looking to cure the
mutant population or looking to reduce
the mutant population and not
necessarily work against them as an
enemy but offer a way for mutants to
become normal humans to suddenly being a
person this like mutants have to survive
we didn't know the answer to that
question but it just simply just
happened that way right it's one of the
things we even mentioned during house
and powers of X and so what you get in
this exchange between Destiny and more
and mctagon is Destiny says understand
every time that you're reincarnated I'm
there we are linked every time that you
come back you have memories of what
happened in the life that you had before
you die and so something to understand
here I see your future right and every
single time that you're reincarnated I
exist in whatever that life happens to
be and I know everything that happens so
I know everything that's going to happen
to you so I know whether or not or I
will know whether or not you will try to
create a mutant cure whether or not you
will try to be some kind of a monster
and destroy the mutant population so she
says when she reveals to her you can be
killed as a little kid it's kind of a
threat right sort of a sort of a threat
that she says like we know how to
destroy you we know how to make sure
that you can never reincarnate you can
never come back to life you can never
enjoy this process of living out an
infinite number of lives in an infinite
number of ways just going on forever and
ever and ever until the universe dies of
heat death and so she says if you ever
over the course of these lives that you
live however many times that you die if
you ever become the person that creates
a formula that will find some way to
destroy the mutant population if you
Ally yourselves with people who will
destroy the mutant population if you do
anything other than help us Thrive I
will be there and we will kill you and
we will kill you however many times we
need to it doesn't matter so she says
change right become a person that helps
the mutant population grow and Thrive
especially because you and I both know
that this this existence of the meat and
population will inevitably always lead
to a war with machines or with man or a
combination of both because she says do
you really believe that Humanity will
just let you have this formula right
that you will have this formula out
there to cure the mutant population in
humanity will say okay cool well we'll
just let the mutants that want to say
mutants we'll let them kind of continue
doing that and those mutants who want to
become human or want to lose their
powers will let them do that too no
Humanity will take that cure from you
they'll weaponize it and they'll use it
to get rid of the mutant population so
she says as long as you are out there as
a person that's doing this you are an
existential threat to the mutant
population's entire existence and so
when the question becomes how do we
ensure that you are that kind of person
how do we make sure that you know to
never work against the mutant population
lest you die in a horrifying way the
response that Mystique gives is I think
the answer is fear and so Destiny says
perhaps there's only one way to find out
and so what she does is she summons pyro
right remember pyro is a mutant that has
the ability to manipulate fire he cannot
create it but he can control it and she
tells pyro kill Maura McTaggart burn her
but do it slowly so she never forgets
what changing feels like right make sure
she suffers slowly and painfully that
was Maura's third life now it goes into
Myra's 10th life right the current one
that we're seemingly in right now so I
guess it's really this one as opposed to
the 11th life but the important thing
here is that as we kind of continue on
we switch over to Maura's no place right
more mctagger you switch over to the no
place the places she exists in in
krakowa where seemingly nobody can get
to where she is right it's basically
underwater right where nobody would
really know that it's there nobody would
know how to access it but when she
arrives through her Cohen gate she's met
by the arrival of Charles Xavier and
Magneto now here's a very very important
distinction and set of events that
unfold here that one of the things that
was kind of given to us is that as the
X-Men Mythos exists right now by a way
of house and powers of X it's all
predicated on the idea that at some
point in the future there will always be
a war between the mutant population and
seemingly everybody else either it'll be
post-humans right so those individuals
those children of the Vault that we've
talked about before in the X-Men Mythos
or it'll be Humanity orcas who have
basically created Nimrod who a wage war
against the mutant population in one way
or another it always leads to a massive
conflict and every single time mutants
are totally destroyed and so it always
seemed to be that this entire concept
was basically an organization a kind of
agreement and even a friendship that was
struck between Charles Xavier Mormon
Taggart and and Magneto what we're
basically given here is this idea that
there's trouble in Paradise man one of
the things that happens is that there's
a statement that's made by Charles
Xavier right like let's not reminisce on
the past right it doesn't help anything
or or anything along those lines and as
the two of them are kind of talking
suddenly that Dawns on Maura McTaggart
like wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute reminiscing about the past like
what are you talking about like like the
two of you were here after I after I
came back through my did you know that I
left and that's when they revealed that
what they had done is is during the
initial meeting of the quiet Council
when they had fed her tea they had
secretly put Nanobots in her body that
had actually coalesced in her elbow that
were developed by Forge so they could
always know where she was they don't
really trust her right they don't really
trust her at all they kind of take her
at her word because the threat that she
presented seemed to be such a
significant threat that they had to take
it seriously right because Charles
Xavier read her mind and realized she
was telling the truth but the honest
truth is that they never wholly believed
her the other part of this is that in
the conversation that they have the
statement made by Mora McTaggart is you
have to destroy Nimrod and you have to
destroy Destiny Destiny can never be
allowed to come back Destiny can never
be allowed to return if she does it
would mean the end of everything but
given the context of the beginning of
the story that doesn't really seem to be
the key case at all it seems like more
mctaggart's lying like she's just saying
that so that she can kind of live out
her life the way she sees fit and then
in turn never have to worry about
Destiny which begs the question if
that's the case if more McTaggart
approached Charles Xavier and said all
these terrible things are going to
happen in the future we got to do
something you know Bill Co and all that
kind of stuff is what she's doing
actually setting the X-Men on on a
collision course with humanity and
ensuring the mutants destruction that's
the question that you have to ask
because that's one of the things that
Magneto and even even Xavier himself
talks about right they say like okay so
here's the thing right like regarding
Nimrod and and the robots and all that
kind of stuff every single time we
launch an attack that it basically has
done nothing more than allowed Humanity
to create these things right so our
actions have really put Humanity on the
path of creating Nimrod right but we did
that at your behest because you said it
was going to happen and we had to
prevent it from happening from there it
goes into the discussion of Mystique and
the idea is that with Destiny having
been a love interest of Mystique I mean
I guess it wasn't necessarily solidified
but it basically was right by all
standards the measurement Marvel told us
that mystique and Destiny have really
had a love interest in each other for
quite some time that with Mystique being
in a position of power she will
inevitably lead to the return of Destiny
and so in order to ensure that doesn't
happen Mystique has to be removed from a
position of power but arbitrarily
getting rid of somebody who's part of
The Quiet council with seemingly no real
motivation given is not an easy thing to
do because while they are on the quiet
Council and while they were founders of
The Quiet Council the quiet Council
itself was founded under the notion of
equality that every member of The Quiet
council is equal to every other member
right this is not George Orwell's Animal
Farm where everybody's equal but some
are more equal than others it's not like
that right or at least it's not supposed
to be that way but what they're
basically really planning here and what
what uh more mctagger is telling them
here is you need to find a way to get
rid of Mystique right sell it on a
season of change right say things are
changing around here everything kind of
changes we're celebrating you know the
the progression of our mutant pop
ovulation and so what they do here and
this is actually a pretty shady
situation is the statement is made here
by Maura McTaggart right she says yes
Mystique has to be erased she says by
now everyone knows the process of how a
mutant is returned from the dead what is
required is for you to seize the means
of Resurrection the five of course
cannot be controlled in any such manner
however the mechanisms by which the
process begins and ends can be control
of the cradles is Paramount and she says
but more important than that is whose
hands Resurrection begins I want you to
collect what remains of Destiny's DNA I
want you to collect it and I want you to
destroy it destroy every ounce of it
destroy it all will you do that for the
future of our nation will you do that
for me literally they're going to just
destroy the existence of Destiny right
preventer from from ever coming into
existence this is pretty shady right
this is a pretty shady thing for
somebody like Charles Xavier or matt
Magneto or anybody to be doing and to a
degree it really seems to be predicated
on the belief that what more McTaggart
is doing is trying to ensure the future
survival of the mutant population and so
in response to this Charles Xavier says
as a show of good faith a symbol of our
realignment we will and then more
McTaggart responds don't lie about this
it's what keeps me up at night it's the
one thing I truly fear and I haven't
slept peacefully for a thousand years I
cannot will not accept her breathing
curcumin air I want her gone forever
burned from all existence and so that's
kind of a crazy thing here is because
they're basically plotting to remove
Mystique from power so Mystique can
never Advocate among the quiet counsel
the return of Destiny because seemingly
more mctaggart's the only one that
really has anything to fear from Destiny
and even if she passed on this notion to
Xavier into Magneto that the return of
Destiny could lead to the destruction of
the mutant population nobody else in the
quiet Council would have any reason to
believe this because they have have no
interaction with more McTaggart and so
if Mystique is able to create a
compelling enough case and saying no
having somebody who can see the future
coming back can help us in ways that we
can't possibly imagine because she will
allow us to counteract threats before
they ever become threats in the first
place right to prepare for what was
previously an unforeseeable future then
she's far more of a benefit than she is
a liability that would sway the quiet
counsel and ensure that Destiny is able
to return and so in order to initiate
this whole thing this whole process of
removing Mystique from power they start
to kind of bring in again this whole
idea of a season of change that you have
Cyclops basically stepping down from any
real position he was in before and
simply saying I can offer myself as a
captain but I cannot be a commander
among the quiet counsel anymore that my
job is to be a field member of the X-Men
team I just can't dedicate time to this
anymore and being a commander requires a
lot of time and dedication and so where
Cyclops steps down Bishop replaces him
right Bishop ends up becoming a
commander which is is a cool moment
right Bishop ship was just a
ridiculously cool character who never
got his dude let me tell you something
man under the right circumstances Bishop
is overpowered man this guy is so cool I
love the character of Bishop but he ends
up becoming a new Commander following
that you switch over to the quiet
Council and them having their meeting
and that's when Xavier and Magneto go in
for the kill that's when they go into
yes it's a season of change everybody
it's a season of progress we're evolving
as we always do we as a mutant
population stand as the representative
Evolution among the human race and how
can we possibly imbue this idea of
evolution if we ourselves do not evolve
therefore we need to evolve the quiet
Council we need to evolve this role the
quiet Council plays and even Magneto
goes as far as to say if it's the will
of the council even I would be willing
to step down if it was required even I
would be willing to accept this
Evolution and move to a lesser position
and so ultimately the two of them turn
their sights to mystique and mystique's
like you know what that's a great idea
guys we've got an open seat on the quiet
Council and I 100 agree it's a time for
change right and so she says I know a
mutant we should consider for the
council and the response of Xavier is
like what and then Magneto tries to cut
her off and says there'll be a time for
that but as a member of The Quiet
Council she can call a vote on anything
anytime she wants to so long as the rest
of the council will let her and she says
the time is now the time for this for
for the calling of this meeting is now I
offer a candidate for this Council who
sits in Dominion of the mutant island of
krakowa come forth mutant and that's
when you get that line that's when you
get that phrase that was told to
Mystique there will be an island not the
first but the last this place will seem
to be hope for Our Kind when those days
come remember these words bring me back
and if you cannot if they will not then
burn the place to the ground and that's
when we end up learning the person
summoned here to the quiet Council By
Mystique is none other than Destiny
fully Resurrected
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are back with Inferno yes we
are God this story is so good like the
ending of this is nuts okay so here's
the thing right so Inferno which you
guys know in the the last video that we
did it was basically the return of
Destiny which was one of the most
terrifying things for like Xavier and
Magneto and those guys because Destiny
is a precog right we're Magneto and
Xavier are able to guide krakowa under
the auspices that they know what's best
for everybody and that they have to just
kind of trust their leadership Destiny
can actually see the future she actually
knows what's going to happen and that's
kind of a crazy thing here because when
you're dealing with someone who knows
the future suddenly the manipulations of
Xavier and Magneto become a lot harder
to implement but what this does is it
actually opens up with really some time
before all of this took place that you
actually have Mystique who basically
begins the process of bringing Destiny
back and that was the question that we
had right how did Destiny somehow manage
to return how did that end up happening
and so what this does is it actually has
Mystique basically traveling to Island
in right the home of Magneto essentially
right using the quinjet she arrives on
the scene then basically takes a helmet
of Xavier makes herself look like
Charles Xavier and then goes to visit
Sinister now the funny thing about this
is Sinister immediately picks up on
what's going on right he's just like
look at you all dressed up always
playing a part as always right like
Sinister immediately knows this is
Mystique now a lot of this goes into
just the nature of sinister himself
right Sinister has been around Mystique
enough times to know what's going on
he's been around here enough times to
know when she's being manipulative and
Xavier wouldn't really just show up and
visit Sinister like this for this
particular thing the other part of this
is that because Sinister hands Mystique
something it looks like it was a
pre-arranged meeting right so the
Sinister already kind of knew that it
was Mystique when she showed up here but
the important thing is that this leads
to Mystique pretending to be Xavier
showing up to the five now as you guys
know the five are the ones who are
responsible for resurrecting dead
mutants and then restoring their
memories to them all that kind of cool
stuff right the whole Resurrection
process now the other thing about this
is that by and large when it comes to
those individuals those members of the
five their belief in Xavier is beyond
contestation they don't question him
they take what Xavier does as an
absolute truth and so when he shows up
and he hands them a vial which is going
to serve the purpose of resurrecting a
dead Mutant and he says this is to bring
this mutant back at the end of the day
they're like okay they don't question
it's not like how did you get this like
what what's going on here like this is
an unexpected Resurrection none of that
happens instead it's just like Okay cool
so of course they inject the vial into
the resurrection pod and then from there
Destiny basically re-emerges now the
cool thing about this and one of the
things to keep in mind when it comes to
Resurrection is you're basically a clean
slate this was Jonathan Hickman
borrowing heavily from the eternals
right the eternals have been doing this
for for eons right for about a million
years or so since their existence every
time an eternal dies they basically come
back in this exact same capacity I mean
it doesn't follow the exact form right
they're not born in an egg instead it's
basically just a body for themselves
that's created by the machine right the
the Earth itself right the the systems
that were left behind by the celestials
and so when the questions asked by uh by
Hope Summers okay Xavier are you ready
to give her her memories of course
whenever Mystique turns into someone she
cannot copy their powers she's not
capable of that so when the questions
asked are you ready Mystique has to find
a way to dodge the question which she
does in a fantastic fashion she actually
plays on the nature of Hope Summers
right so for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with this after the Scarlet
Witch had taken away 98 of the mutant
population's Powers hopes Summers was
the first mutant who was born after what
was referred to as M day and in fact she
is hugely powerful but the reason why
she's called Hope Summers is because she
was adopted by cable who's a child of
Cyclops and Madeleine Pryor the fact
that hope looks like Jean Gray in a lot
of ways that was Marvel initially
teasing the idea that Jean Gray was
going to come back and then basically
pulling the rug out from everybody and
saying actually it's a girl named hope
you know and that was basically it right
it's not Jean Gray it's just a girl
named Hope and she looks like Jean
Grange Jean Gray will maybe come back at
a future point in time but the thing
about this is that Mystique plays on
that it says like you're one of the most
powerful mutants in existence that's why
we put you here as part of the
Resurrection process like literally Hope
Summers has the ability to duplicate the
powers of anybody she's around and
amplify the powers of people's shoes
around right there's seemingly no upper
limit to those Powers we haven't seen
how far it can go but I imagine it can
go pretty daggone far but Hope Summers
is kind of like I mean I've I've never
done this before so yeah sure I'm
definitely excited about this right and
so at that point mystique's like cool
right here's the helmet do your thing
and so as hope goes through and
basically finds what is an effect the
memories or the the personality traits
of Destiny and then plants them into her
mind then at that point Mystique again
pretending to be Xavier is like well
this is a very very delicate process
right so I'll hang back here and get
this sorted out you guys go celebrate
and do your thing right which basically
kind of shunts them off and then
following that it's the recovery process
now this if anything was a testament to
the relationship between mystique and
Irene Adler right mystique and Destiny
that given the history of these two
write the Romantic relationship they've
had the fact that they've been together
for so long the death of Destiny was
this just crushing moment for a Mystique
right because in that moment she had
seemingly lost everything that meant
anything to her in her life for Destiny
herself to be returned to mystique and
from Mystique to have her back creates a
sense of unity and wholeness that
neither one of them have had for quite
some time the kicker to this is that
because of the fact that Destiny has
been gone for so long that all these
things that have happened in the past
and all these things that are going to
happen in the future just come flooding
back at one time and that was kind of
the nature of Destiny right because as
she began to use her powers and realize
what she was capable of that where they
started off as dreams then she started
to realize they were actually
precognitive Visions she was able to
ease into it and she was able to kind of
grasp everything that was happening
because she was able to see them at a
reasonable and slow pace because they
were coming at a reasonable and slow
pace right this is like you not reading
comics for like 15 years and then I come
along with every single issue of comics
that you missed and just sitting him in
front of you and say here you go right
it's it's overwhelming it's immensely
overwhelming and so for her it just it
almost kind of seems to shut her down
right it's just it's more than she can
handle and so what we get is this kind
of explanation that the first week that
Destiny returned by the seemingly
endless atemporal waves of future
possibilities that were completely and
totally alien to her right she was lost
a Seer out of time but as hard as the
first week was the second week was most
difficult why because Love Brought
Destiny back that and the underlying
loyalty of a wife desperate to be
reunited with her wife however while
Destiny was unchanged Frozen in time
from the time they last saw one another
Mystique had changed it's not as though
she died like a year and a half ago
right so it's like right before the
events of krakowa she's been gone for a
long long time and everything that
happened in between made Mystique harder
and a lot of that was just because of
the fact that Mystique really
experiencing the death of Destiny losing
something that significant to her made
her a hard person and the funny thing
about it is that this kind of hardness
that Mystique had that was a shell that
was an exterior that Mystique didn't
think she was still that vulnerable
anymore and talking to Destiny and and
see and actually realizing right the
reality of the situation that Destiny is
truly back it's not some kind of vision
it's not like she gets to have a moment
with her she is actually back
forevermore until such a time as she
dies in the future just overwhelms
mystique and she just just totally falls
apart it's not something she thought she
could experience anymore but the
important thing is that with that the
two of them now being back together they
have a they have a heart where they have
a greater purpose so so week three was
them just kind of enjoying the company
of one another right week four was
making plans and so that goes into the
the final issue that we had which was
Destiny being brought on to the quiet
Council now here's the issue everyone
here knows who Destiny is they know who
she is they know what she's capable of
right they know what she stands for and
so Xavier is just kind of like okay so I
have two votes that I want to call right
and then Destiny immediately calls him
on the first one and says you really
want to vote to get Mystique out of here
because I can tell you exactly how it's
gonna happen right so then that leads
into the second vote right and the
second vote is basically to allow
Destiny on the quiet Council now
seemingly Des Destiny knows how all this
is gonna play out but this is a genius
move by Jonathan Hickman he doesn't tell
us right Destiny doesn't even tell us
she doesn't say like here's how it's all
actually going to happen here's what's
going to take place here because in
reality if she did it would seemingly
curtail the vote I would have to imagine
in this particular scenario that it
would be better it would be more
interesting for Destiny really more
enjoyable to watch Xavier and to watch
Magneto fail than it is to basically
tell them that they're going to fail
right to see the shock on their faces
not only that a lot of back alley deals
have been made here right that what you
of course have is is Magneto and Xavier
who are like no Destiny cannot join the
quiet Council right storm votes against
it as well but then Nightcrawler votes
yes but he only votes yes because he
wants to appease his mom which actually
Mystique was counting on from there it
goes to Exodus now vinodu Paris has
always been just this really really
interesting character right he's
stupidly powerful right I mean his
telepathy is is astronomical right I
mean this guy is is I would say he's
Beyond anybody here right Beyond Emma
Frost and Beyond Xavier kind of depends
on the circumstance but he was created
by apocalypse right this guy's power is
virtually unrivaled by any of the
superheroes on Earth you know minus the
reality warpers and you gotta throw
those in there but there was a deal that
was struck between Destiny and exodus
right and that Exodus basically said
like over the course of my life I've
been used for one cause or the other but
here on krakowa I'm My Own man right no
one uses me here I have my own outlook
on this world I make my own decisions
and I decide what my fate will be so if
you are going to come to me and you are
going to ask me for your support in
bringing somebody on and you're not
telling me who they are or what they're
capable of or why you even want them in
the first place then I can't be bribed
here you're going to have to give me a
good reason now Exodus is what you call
a Believer this guy believes in crocola
right because it's really the only place
that one he's felt safe and two he's
felt like he belonged and so that's what
Mystique says the person that I'm
bringing on here can ensure the survival
of this place that she says like there
is a profit to be resurrected right now
Exodus very much believes in the idea of
prophets he believes in the idea yeah
those individuals out there that can
ensure their Survival by seeing their
future and so because that's such an
intricate part of his character she says
like what if I told you that Prophet had
a name and that name was the same as
what she offered a destiny what would
you say then and the response of Exodus
is I'm in right like he she he
immediately is in so he of course votes
yes right at that point it follows up to
the point when she went to go visit
Sinister again all of this happening
before the actual vote for for Destiny
and of course she says like I need your
help with this and he's like why would I
do that like give me a good give me a
good argument right give me a good point
why should I side with you here right I
mean honestly I have my own motivations
but I also kind of enjoy seeing you fail
Mystique so why in the world would I
agree to to support you and your demands
you know illuminate good thespian spell
it out for me and she's like it's simple
actually everybody else is going to
demand that you do it and sinister's
like no one tells Sinister what to do
I'm down
[Laughter]
so that's one of the funniest moments
for him so he's like I vote Yes Kitty
pride of course is like no not a chance
and then at that point they're tied four
to four so then it goes to uh to
Sebastian Shaw and Sebastian Shaw while
you would expect the fact that he has a
grudge against Kitty pride and Emma
Frost and in turn would vote like in
support of it just to spite Kitty Pride
it's actually a little bit deeper than
that it's actually exactly what you
would expect it would be like there's
actually there's a kind of fencing thing
right it's just them kind of doing their
thing right Sebastian Shaw loves fencing
and she's having a conversation with him
while all this is going on and he's like
so what do you intend to bribe me or
something she's like no I mean what
exists beyond the purse or the black
king right there's nothing out there in
the world that you can buy she's like so
I'll give you a good reason right I'll
give you a better reason for why you
should vote in support of this and when
he asked what that reason is he's like I
know for a fact that Emma Frost is gonna
vote against it and so Sebastian's like
I'm in right that's one of the things
like like where you could look at this
and you could say oh my God look it's
just Jonathan Hickman doing stupid stuff
no the cool thing about this is It's
Petty grudges that you look at the the
quiet Council and what you expect is for
something grander here right you expect
these individuals who sit on this
governing body of the the mutant
population right the whole of the mutant
population lives and dies by the
decisions that the quiet Council makes
and you expect them to rise above such
Petty things but the message that
Hickman is conveying here is no at the
end of the day they're every bit as
Petty as you think they are they see
themselves as being something better
when in reality they're not and so what
you do is you switch over to really this
final vote right that you basically have
a five to four vote that you basically
have yet another tied vote and so you
end up switching to Emma Frost and at
that point what Mystique has done here
was his bribe Emma Frost where she
presents her with something that Emma's
been trying to get her hands on for
quite some time Mystique was able to
secure it and then when she brings it to
Emma the response is I will give it to
you but only if you will do something
for me right there's going to be a vote
at the next council meeting and the
white king and the White Queen is going
to vote Yes and so Emma Frost does that
and what it does is it solidifies the
role of Destiny on the quiet Council and
so at that point we switch over to Orcas
now one of the cool things that
Hickman's done here if you guys recall
with orcas they're more akin to
something like Advanced idea mechanics
right or like The Enclave or something
like that that while they are composed
of advanced idea mechanics and Hydra and
all that kind of stuff all these
different uh scientific minds and even
in some cases straight up villainous
Minds that they're largely operating
behind the scenes right they were
responsible for bringing Nimrod online
and all that kind of stuff but they've
largely been working to try to find a
way to take out the entirety of the
mutant population seemingly by trying to
find a way to hijack their Gates but the
important thing here is that while the
initial Mission or this initial attempt
is yet another failure they've made a
little more progress than they did
before but you get a little bit of of
mystery going on here in the sense that
you have omega who again is formerly an
Omega Sentinel those created by Bastion
who was a merging of the original Nimrod
and the Sentinel Creator Master Mold
into one mind that Omega still kind of
exists out there but is basically
serving or operating seemingly against
the mutant population that has this
conversation with nimir and one of the
things that we learn here is that
nimrod's been running simulations in
effect Nimrod has been growing smarter
that nimrod's been running all these
different simulations trying to make
himself more powerful more capable what
if he faces off against this mutant or
that mutant different things like that
facing his own destruction and then
coming back again that sort of a thing
and the whole idea behind this is that
apparently that they are ready for some
kind of a conversation we don't really
know what it is we're not really given
any explanation here instead it's just
very very Cloak and Dagger but I cover
this because I feel like that's going to
become very important later on down the
line if I'm being honest with you I
think Omega is a spy I think she's
working for the X-Men population on
Orcas and pretending to be a villain
because she was at one point kind of a
hero right so I think that's what's
really going on with it I don't know but
I'd like to believe that that's what's
actually taking place but the other part
of this is that if you guys recall the
last video that Destiny had actually
caught up to Maura McTaggart when she
realized what Mormon tiger was doing
dying coming back reliving these lives
different things like that and the
warning she gave her is that if you
continue this we will destroy you right
we'll officially kill you we'll go back
to you when you were a little child
before your powers manifest and will
destroy you so that you are officially
dead forevermore what more McTaggart is
doing here flies in the face of the
order she was given by mystique and
Destiny more so than that the fact that
Destiny's returned seems to really
indicate that like more McTaggart is
facing her own mortality she's afraid
she's gonna die and that's what she says
like destiny it'll take her no time at
all to figure out what's going on with
you guys right to figure out that
there's something that you guys are
doing you're working with some third
party and then from that point it's only
a matter of time before she realizes
it's me and when that happens sure her a
Mystique they'll burn all this down
they'll destroy all of this they'll kill
you then they'll kill me right they will
come after us and so at that point it's
kind of like okay they kind of get into
this discussion about like we have to
kill Destiny now this is a side of Mora
McTaggart at least as is hinted at this
is a side of Maura McTaggart that Xavier
Magneto haven't seen before and that's
the important thing to understand that
for more of mctagger's perspective this
kind of Greater goal of ensuring the
mutant population's survival or at least
that seems to be the case that's the
most important thing and everybody here
including Xavier and Magneto themselves
they're Expendable and so seeing that
from more mctaggart's perspective while
it doesn't lead them to abandon Maura
McTaggart it does change the way they
see her right it's just kind of like
she's having this discussion about like
the pragmatic action of just killing
Destiny and when the questions asked
like can you guys do it Magneto says I
mean she wears and held a metal helmet
on her head right like I could just
crush the helmet and kill her but I'm
not going to do that and when the
questions ask why he says like it or not
she sits on the council I'm not a child
I can tolerate a certain level of
pragmatism when it comes to how things
are run here in Paradise but I have
waited my whole life for this place I
will not defile it just because you find
it expedient right it's it's kind of an
amazing stance from Magneto that from
his perspective this mutant nation of
krakowa a land where the mutant
population can live absent the fear of
death at the hand of the human
population is what he's always wanted
the way he's gone about it has been
questionable over the years but at the
end of the day he does say however there
is still a seat that needs Phil maybe we
make our own offer that cannot be
refused now when he's talking about this
he's not talking about the idea of The
Quiet counsel he's talking about this
inner Council right that they bring
somebody in they bring someone in and
give them the truth of what's Happening
Here that Moore McTaggart and Charles
Xavier and and Magneto are working
together that there's actually a grander
plan at play here and seemingly no one
else out there in the quiet Council or
the entire mutant population know about
it and so what you end up doing is
switching over to what is basically this
kind of uh this this scenario at the
Louvre when this telepathic instructions
are given to all the tourists there and
when they're all gone they end up
bringing in Emma Frost that Emma Frost
from their perception is the one person
they can trust now there's good reason
for this right there's good reason for
this Emma Frost yes she did historically
start out as a villain when she was
introduced in the old X-Men stories by
Chris Claremont right she was a member
of the hellfire club but the death of
the hellions changed Emma Frost right
the hellions were like her own version
of the New Mutants right her own kind of
teenage villainous team and they would
constantly fight against the New Mutants
but the actions of Emma Frost that grab
a huge conflict the death of the
hellions themselves changed her
irrevocably and so that's why she
actually joined the X-Men and then
became the leader of Generation X and
has essentially been a hero ever since
it changed the way in which she saw the
world her loyalties to kirkoa to Xavier
to Magneto to the cause they are Beyond
contestation here no one could ever
question that that she has done a couple
of unsavory things but at the end of the
day it was all for furthering the
mission of Xavier and Magneto so when
they come to her and they say we want
you to be a part of this that when she
initially sees more mctagger she's like
okay that's kind of cool I thought you
were dead but if she is really the
center of all of this then why she's a
human right why would a human be at the
center of the formation of kakoa and the
motivation and reasoning for why it was
done and the response of Xavier is she's
not a human she's a mutant and if you
don't believe me read her mind right
it'd be a much easier thing for Emma
Frost to read the mind of Maura
McTaggart than for them to like sit down
and explain everything right so she
literally does that reads the mind of
Maura McTaggart and then it's just kind
of over overwhelmed by what she sees
this Grand motivation and all this stuff
but then at that point she's like don't
touch me I don't want to have anything
to do with any of you and of course the
response of Magneto is I understand how
you feel it was difficult when I first
learned of all of this and then the
question is asked how long ago was that
how long ago was it that you learned
about this that you learned about all
these Futures where the entire mutant
population is totally obliterated
completely and totally wiped out that
mormick tiger came to you with all this
stuff and said we're gonna form cocoa
we're gonna do all this stuff for the
grander good how long was it that you
knew about that and the question is
dodged right the question is dodged
quite a bit right like they've never
really give her a definitive answer and
so more mctagger steps up and says okay
fine you feel left out that's
understandable but notice she says here
but that's looking at all of this the
wrong way outside of us you're the first
one that we let in and the response of
Xavier is because we trust you and the
response of Magneto is it's more than
that we need you Emma your nation needs
you they try to appeal to her I guess
patriotism if you want to call it that
and she Ponders for a second of course
notice she turns into her Diamond form
which you can't read her mind in her
Diamond form and she says of course for
the children but because of the fact of
of everything that's happened because
she was essentially sold a Lie by Xavier
and Magneto she was never told the truth
about what all is happening here despite
the fact that she has displayed over and
over and over again that her loyalties
are to never be questioned she says
you've manipulated me for years and now
I can see what kind of threat a pre-cod
represents well I am a true mutant I sit
on the council so I'll give the matter
the proper consideration but my loyalty
you arrogant fools have lost that
forever now this is huge because the
question They're laughing left asking
here is did we just make an enemy out of
Emma Frost and if they did she's the
last person you want to make an enemy
out of because while Xavier and Magneto
are the ones that kind of run this whole
show the reality is all these different
members of The Quiet Council storm and
Nightcrawler Mystique Destiny now Emma
Frost Exodus Sebastian Shaw they've all
got their own contacts they've all got
their own networks private Networks
public networks underground networks
black markets different things like that
the last thing you want is someone like
Emma Frost that has wildly high levels
of telepathy that have the Loyalty of a
lot of mutants at her disposal and has
her own network to be your enemy because
Emma Frost could be a one-man Army not
only that she's intricate to Cocoa so
all she has to do is just cut off the
entirety of krakowa's ability to send
its medicines out into the world or to
seed some kind of disdain against the
mutant population by sowing lies in the
minds of people using her telepathy and
suddenly they have this just massive
Calamity they have to contend with
there's a thousand ways she could screw
over Xavier and Magneto it's the last
person you want to have against you and
so following that a final vote is issued
for a missing seat right for the final
seat of the of the the quiet Council
right this final vote issue Xavier says
we've put the name forth that name has
rung out right so you guys are about to
vote on this person a mutant to join our
number and fill the final seat of The
Quiet Council so now we vote and so at
that point sinister's like you know what
I don't like the way this one looks so
no Exodus votes yes Mystique votes no
right Kitty Pride votes yes Emma Frost
votes yes Sebastian Shaw of course votes
no because he's a dick Nightcrawler is
like I am Overjoyed to vote Yes right
I've known this person for a very long
time storm says yes right Xavier yes
Magneto yes Destiny no and so it's 744
against and he says we have once again
added to our number now we are whole
welcome brother we are honored to have
Colossus join the quiet Council
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Inferno yes our monthly
series which covers all the X-Men stuff
and in this video we're actually going
to get some huge revelations in terms of
just what all's been going on here and
that not everything is what you expected
to be which is exactly what I expected
because it's Jonathan Hickman so here's
the thing what this does is it goes all
the way back to the beginnings of
krakowa now if you guys recall Cipher
was just kind of like the guy who
seemingly believed in Charles Xavier no
matter what right that Cipher is the one
that can basically discern any alien
language whatsoever and the whole basis
behind percoa is that itself is well was
technically a mutant that merged with an
island but it's basically a living
Island and that it made perfect sense as
far as Charles Xavier is concerned that
if the mutants were gonna have their own
uh their own place to live their own
Utopia essentially it should be an
island that is in effect a mute and that
Cipher would bridge the gap between the
island itself and the mutant population
essentially be able to communicate with
it on the half of the mutant population
and turn it into the Utopia that they
needed and so where Cypher didn't
initially understand everything that was
going on Xavier of course basically gave
him like a mental image of what he
imagined seeing and then it was really
up to cypher from there to start
building on it right to start turning it
into something now what we also end up
finding out here is that along the way
uh Cipher Doug it basically brought in
warlock now warlock we've kind of talked
about before but what sort of of rehash
this too you know for a bit for people
who are a little unfamiliar with that or
don't really know who he is at all so
warlock's a long-standing member of the
X-Men community and he's actually the
precursor to the Phalanx right so what
you had here is basically a group called
the technarchy uh and they were
essentially kind of like living
Machinery now when warlock arrived on
Earth that also coincided well really it
was actually a few years later but and
coincided with a guy named Cameron Hodge
the desire of Cameron Hodge who was
initially the benefactor of the original
X Factor team is that he was he was so
anti-mutant that he actually took what
was in effect Warlock and then tried to
merge him with human physio apology and
by doing so created the Phalanx race as
we know it but that's kind of how
warlock ties into those things now he's
not really a member of the thing likes
himself instead he's actually the son of
the king of the technoric and basically
just fled because he didn't want to be
confined to that life or anything along
those lines but the the big thing here
the big important thing here is that
Doug trusts warlock implicitly right he
trusts him absolutely and for a good
reason like they've got a lot of history
together but one of the things that he
says and this is something that we
weren't even aware of is that when we
initially read this it was Xavier
dropping off Cipher and saying here you
go man turn this into something that'll
make the mutant Nation proud and Doug
was like I'll do everything I can
Professor X and then you know Professor
X left and that was basically it what we
end up getting is the other half of that
that Doug never trusted Professor Xavier
he asked him like he says like so the
professor has plans tell me warlock do
you trust him and the response of
warlock is no self friend experience
says that we do not trust Charles Xavier
now that's an important thing to
understand here the X-Men as they were
originally written by Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby and even in the early days of
Chris Claremont you look at giant size
X-Men by by Lynn wine there were
basically a lot of reasons to trust
Xavier he was a bit of a creep because
like he had a crush on on Jean Gray
which is really kind of strange because
she's gotten older and he hasn't so you
really gotta gotta wonder why in the
world that works the way it does but the
thing about this is that uh Professor X
really the the first major instance I
would say of the mutant population
destructing Professor X and really more
the X-Men than anything else I would say
was probably X-Men deadly Genesis that
was like a huge Revelation when you
ended up finding out between the the
basically the defeat of the original
X-Men team when krakowov was first
introduced in Marvel Comics and like the
new team that he formed and I guess
giant size expert number one by Lynn
wine so like Colossus will rain storm
all those characters coming together for
the first time that the X-Men deadly
Genesis story in the mid-2000s actually
revealed that he had a secret mutant
team that nobody knew about now that's
not to say that he was wholeheartedly
trusted up into that point there were a
lot of instances when Xavier established
the fact that either he was a dick or
because of his mental state that he
couldn't be trusted so things like the
onslaught Saga were a really big example
in the sense that he was so frustrated
with Humanity that when he shut down the
mind of Magneto Magneto's hatred for
Humanity merged with Professor Xavier's
frustration with humanity and formed the
the onslaught entity so we've seen
multiple instances over the years when
Xavier's done some pretty nefarious
stuff and so it makes sense that even if
they are kind of going with the idea
there is a little bit of distrust there
but we'll actually find out just how far
reaching this goes because the first
response that Doug has is okay we'll
cross that bridge when we get to it for
right now we need to turn this into
something now following that what you
end up learning is that the island of
krakowa had in effect merged with
warlock and this was all done in you
know for an intended purpose what that
intended purpose is we'll find out at a
future point in time but it's one of
those things where dog kind of having
his secret conversations with or I guess
his personal conversations with the
island of krakawa was always asking like
how do you feel about the idea of CR of
being turned into an island nation for
the mutant population then it turns into
how do you feel about like millions of
mutants living here different things
along those lines right that in a lot of
ways krakowa seemed to kind of go with
it but didn't necessarily seem to be a
big fan of it but it was one of those
things where it was really like Warlock
and gracoa and Cipher kind of working
together in secret so nobody would
really know exactly what it was that
they were doing now again the role
warlock plays will become very important
later on down the line but one of the
things to also know is that at the
outset the nature of krakowa is that in
order to sustain itself it has to feed
on Life Energy and that's one of the
reasons why krakowa just kind of seemed
to go along with that is because as time
progresses what you would basically have
is all these mutants occupying this
place and instead of feeding on the the
life energies of like five mutants like
he did in the original giant size X-Men
number one which I have which was
autographed for me by Jonathan Hickman
and I'll never get rid of uh that
instead it can feed on the life energies
of millions of mutants but it can still
sustain itself the same way so tiny
little bits of energy versus huge chunks
of energy so again it's kind of an
interesting thing but but of course Doug
working directly with with gracoa and
all that kind of stuff end up basically
creating the krakowan gates which we're
aware of they allowed the cocoons or at
least the mutant population of hash from
one location to the next all that kind
of stuff but along the way all these
discussions that they have it always
kind of seems to be that they don't
necessarily trust Professor X and all
this comes to a head when it turns into
what's basically the place where no
one's supposed to know about right the
place that morimetiger exists kind of
like a null space we're sort of in
prakoa but hidden away from cocoa and
not even krakowa itself can see it right
in the sense that Doug basically says
like this is going to create the habitat
that they requested the one that nobody
can gain access to here's the kicker
right he says like you kakoa will not be
able to see this they've requested that
what they don't know is that warlock has
basically merged with you so while you
can't see it warlock can't so warlock
will be our eyes and ears on everything
that's going on with regards to this
little secret habitat so we can know
what's happening and that's when we end
up finding out that Doug Ramsey right
and krakowa and warlock all basically
know about Maura McTaggart and they know
that Destiny's back and they know that
Maury McTaggart wants to kill Destiny
and what this does is it confirms the
suspicions that Doug Ramsey had that
Professor Xavier and Magneto cannot be
trusted while he doesn't seem to know
the exact ins and outs of what's going
on because they don't discuss every
single little Nuance inside of this
little this little secret habitat he has
solidified enough to know they've got
some kind of secret plans that no one's
supposed to know about that they could
in effect get the mutant population
killed potentially that's an important
thing here and so following that you
basically switch over to uh Destiny and
Mystique who have been summoned by Emma
Frost now this is a really really cool
encounter right because Destiny died
long before the Stepford cacus were ever
introduced right they describe
themselves as a singular entity split
into five parts and of course Mystique
introduces them as five parts
representing a singular into T it's all
the same thing they're splitting hairs
at this point right as semantics but
like it's five plus two versus two plus
five it's all basically the same thing
and so as a result of that they kind of
try to establish their dominance here to
you know a little bit like no Mystique
that's not what we represent this is
what we represent which is basically the
same thing you said just saying it a
different way and so Destiny's like hmm
do you know who I am and they're like
yeah like your destiny they say you're
the most powerful Clairvoyant mutant to
ever live and she's like yes do you know
what I see when I look into the eyes of
all five of you and their question is
what and she says I see two who will
find love three who will not one who
will be changed forever severed from the
five and other world itself and one of
you will never recover from it right
that was the nature of Destiny she
always answered in riddles and one of
the things that the the stepper acouza
kind of put off is a destiny and
Mystique can't possibly comprehend them
right because then at the end of the day
they kind of change who it is that wears
like this black outfit so they could
differentiate or at least the rest of
the world can differentiate between each
of them because the world just couldn't
tell tell the difference if they all
were white and so on and so forth and so
when the question is asked like well
which one of us is going to go through
this the responsive Destiny is like how
would I know there isn't any difference
between any of you you're all basically
the same right and then walks away and
it's one of those things where it's it's
not like super significant but it's
basically Destiny busting the balls of
uh of the Stephen Coos right the stepper
Coos are getting tested by Destiny
that's basically what it is busting
their balls to see how they react but
it's one of those those funny little
little moments here right because kind
of going into that the discussion that
takes place between Emma Frost mystique
and Destiny is pretty significant here
and the reason why is because if you
guys recall at the end of the last video
we basically talked about how Emma Frost
was brought in by Professor Xavier and
Magneto and given essentially the the
truth about everything that's been going
on but the fact that they'd held it from
her for so incredibly long despite the
fact that she's been a long-standing
member of the X-Men community and that
if anybody on the council has earned the
trust to know what's going on that it
should have been her it felt like a
massive Trail it felt like they just
didn't trust her and so at the end of
the day she just ended up storming off
she you know of course wasn't going to
blab their secrets to the world so she
wasn't going to work against them but
she wasn't gonna work with them either
and that's what she establishes here
that she's very much on her own and
that's kind of how it's always been for
Emma Frost right she's always kind of
been on her own the only exception to
that is when she first encountered and
really began to lead generation X or
really when she first created and then
LED Generation X up to that point in
time even when she was part of the
hellfire club she was very much alone
right she was very much isolated just
kind of a core part of her character but
what she basically tells mystique and
Destiny is that more mctaggart's alive
and where they initially reject the
possibility she gives them just what is
in effect a mental indication or a
mental view of one of Mormon Tiger's
lives remember all that information was
given to Emma Frost by Professor Xavier
so she can pass it on to other people if
she chooses and so she basically shows
Destiny in and Mystique this is the
nature of more McTaggart as a mutant
right she is a mutant she is not a human
she has the ability to die and then
resurrect and that in in and of itself
is what makes her so powerful is she can
wipe away our timeline right all she has
to do is just die and then do something
different and our timeline doesn't exist
anymore now again this is Marvel kind of
changing the rules of time travel that
in years past Marvel would have said no
no this timeline would just keep going
the new reality that Maura mckaggart
wakes up in is a new is is like a new
timeline in and of itself so you know if
you've got the First Time Warren
mctagger died that's timeline one the
second time she died timeline two third
time she died timeline three so on and
so forth but they never cease to exist
all those timelines keep going now by
all standards and measurement they might
as well not exist because there isn't
really in a readily available means for
the mutants to like hop from one
dimension to the next right from one
Universe to the other other people can
right but the mutants are very much
self-contained so unless they absolutely
need the help of like Doctor Strange or
the Fantastic Four they won't really
like leave and go explore other
universes or anything along those lines
so while those doors aren't necessarily
pad locked in the most extreme they
might as well be as far as a mutant
population is concerned because with the
tools available to them they can't
readily jump from one Universe to the
next and so that's kind of the crazy
thing is because at the end of the day
Destiny ends up realizing that while
Emma Frost isn't going to necessarily
work with them she's not going to work
against them but she has brought things
that they can use to basically help
right things that they can use to kind
of work against Professor X and more
McTaggart to a degree under the idea
that everything they're doing will
actually get the mutant population
killed and that's one of the funny
things that Hickman really seems to be
hitting out of here but doesn't really
seem to be explicitly said is that say
for example Mormon McTaggart would have
died right she'll be fine she'll live on
she'll continue on and then she'll
likely end up grabbing Charles Xavier
and Magneto and they'll you know she'll
kind of tell them everything that was
going on but you know Professor X will
read her mind he'll pass that
information on a Magneto and they'll
essentially be all caught up for
everyone else sorry about your luck
right for the life that Emma Frost was
formed for herself here that's gone for
the life that anybody else has formed
here that's gone but in a lot of ways
they all seem to be Pawns in the game
that that more mctaggard Charles Xavier
and Magneto are Plank and that's one of
the things really probably the biggest
thing that pisses off Emma Frost more
than anything else is that they brought
her in because they felt like they had
to not necessarily because they wanted
to and so basically this whole situation
kind of unfolds with uh more Mitch
Haggard coming out of her safe house
which exists outside of gracoa itself
and once she emerges she's immediately
set upon by the forces of orcas and then
essentially whisked away now it's kind
of a crazy thing because once you
transition over to the orcus forge you
basically pick up with Omega talking to
Nimrod and this is where things get
interesting because what happens here is
that Nimrod has already picked up on the
fact that Omega is not supposed to be
here right that she's not part of this
timeline she's from somewhere else in
the time stream now this was like an
itch that I couldn't scratch because I
knew I wasn't crazy when I first started
reading this I was like okay I'm I'm for
the most part caught up on the X-Men
there's a few things in I'm missing here
and there but for the most part I'm
caught up but how in the world did Omega
go from the character that we last Saw
to this character here what's going on
here and so what she basically reveals
is that she's from the future but the
future she comes from in all those
different timelines the mutant
population always wins and that's
something that Jonathan Hickman had
never actually specified if you go back
and you read house and powers of X that
more McTaggart seemed to come from it
from the perspective that like the
mutant population always loses but then
Omega comes along and says the mutant
population always wins and so what it
looks like is they're coming from two
distinctly different sets of
circumstances in terms of how the mutant
machine and human war ends up unfolding
either that or one of them's lying one
of them's not telling the truth and so
because of this she basically explains
at least in her timeline how it all
unfolds and in the various timelines
that she seems to have experienced now
whether or not she's in the same on the
same capacity as as more of a Taggart
isn't really explained here I would
argue that's probably not the case but
the important thing here is that at some
point along the line the post-human race
right the children of the ball the ones
that we'd seen that story on where like
x-23 and sinking them had gone into the
Vault and then like barely escape with
their lives and like x23 I think was the
only one who made it out alive I don't
remember which one lived but like those
people there so basically hyper-evolved
humans uh that they would emerge From
the Vault the problem is they would
emerge too early and that apocalypse
would return from arako and basically
slaughter them all and then a war would
break out between humanity and the
mutant population but the mutant
population would start to gain the upper
hand in a last-ditch effort to basically
win the human population would create
the Sentinel program and then by
extension they would launch Nimrod and
that in creating nemrod it just wasn't
really as powerful as they needed it to
be because at that point in time what
had happened is the mutant population
was on the verge of complete and total
Destruction now there was a side project
going on which we'll talk about here in
a second but the mutant population was
basically on the verge of Destruction
and so what would happen is that they
would send Nimrod into the past with the
hope that it could destroy the mutant
population in its infancy something I
can to like Skynet and Terminator right
like basically what they were shooting
for here but that Nimrod would always
fail now here's a funny thing about this
right if you go and you read new X-Men
Volume 2 there's a four-part story
called Nimrod and for years and years
and years people would debate whether or
not that version of nimrod that was
fought in New Mutants Volume 2 was the
same Nimrod or like a uh I guess the
version of nimrod that returned from
like the old school days right from the
Days of Future Past universe that went
into the past and then basically merged
with uh master mold in The Siege
perilous and then went on to become
Bastion what Hickman seem to be doing
here is saying no that version of nimrod
they fought in uh in in New Mutants
volume two that's this guy it's this guy
and he's arriving in the past from this
present here right from this future so I
don't know if that's true he doesn't
really say all they were really told is
that that version of nimrod goes into
the past and then is ultimately
destroyed right so again we're not
really given a definitive answer but I
feel feel like it'd be a very nice and
elegant way to kind of answer that
question that has really been plaguing
the fan base since like the mid-2000s
but ultimately what would happen is that
you would have Humanity which would
merge with machine technology kind of
creating like the new post humans and
that in doing so they would begin to
gain the upper hand on the mutant
population the problem with this is the
mutant population had Cosmic Powers at
their disposal more specifically the
blade of the Phoenix now the blade of
the Phoenix is a sword that can only be
wielded by rookshire Brookshire of
course being a member of the shiar
Empire and if you guys recall what we've
seen so far especially at the beginning
of New Mutants as part of the dawn of X
line is that the mutant population
formed an alliance with the Shia Empire
right now rookshire himself was actually
a member of the shiar who ended up
basically gaining the gaining accessor
was a host for the Phoenix Force the
Phoenix blade can only be wielded by the
descendants of rookshire right like his
direct family line people who share his
blood anybody else who tries to pick it
up will either be destroyed by it or
it'll just be a random sword but they'll
never be able to use it in the same
capacity using the full totality of what
it can do with its small Shard of the
Phoenix which is imbued to the sword but
in this future during this war between
uh basically the post-human race the the
human machine hybrid race and the mutant
population that where the mutant
population found itself on the verge of
being destroyed that what would happen
is that post-humanity would basically
draw the attention of the Phalanx race
right that race out there that basically
is kind of like the super Advanced
machine race that would achieve higher
states of power and they would literally
travel around the universe after
seemingly absorbing the cosmic entities
and then in turn start like turning
various worlds to their cost but once
the planet had achieved a higher level
of technological development that the
Phalanx would see them as worth
assimilating into their race and the
Phalanx would arrive on Earth because of
the the attempt of the human machine
hybrid to draw the attention of the
phalanes in the hope that one the
Phalanx would destroy what was left in
the meat in population because they
wouldn't see them them as being worth
merging with and two that the the
post-human race would find this kind of
perfection by being merged with the fan
Lakes Race itself what would actually
happen in these timelines at least in
terms of omega's understanding of it is
that using the Phoenix Blade the sword
of rookshire that the mutant population
would actually destroy these these
Phalanx individuals as they arrived on
Earth they would wipe them out and
because of the fact that they were using
what was in effect Godly technology
there was nothing the post-human race
could do so they would die off as well
and in the end that's how the mutant
population would reign supreme that's
how they would dominate everything now
in order to keep that from happening
which is a very reminiscent scenario
from Days of Future Past is that omega's
Consciousness was basically sent into
the past into this body for the purpose
of allowing her to basically warn uh the
human population to ensure that humans
could come out on top so that's what
really kind of blew my mind on this is
that in the original Days of Future Past
timeline it was the Sentinels that
conquered North America and then
eventually the world and so basically
humans and mutants were subjugated by
The Sentinel population and the
Sentinels basically ended up just kind
of going awry just continuing on and
then seemingly dominating everything
what this is is basically the antithesis
that as far as Omega is concerned this
is essentially Days of Future Past
except it's humans and they're merging
with machine technology becoming
post-humans that are essentially
subjugated and eventually destroyed by
the mutant population and the mutants
went out and so much like the original
Days of Future Past her mind is sent to
the past to keep this from happening the
way Kitty Pride warned the mutant
population that the assassination of
Senator Moore McTaggart uh Robert Kelly
and and Professor Xavier would lead to
the launching or the the return of the
Sentinel program under Stephen Lang and
eventually Days of Future Past omega's
here to warn the human population of the
mutants impending Victory she's kind of
working quietly behind the scenes that
Dr Killian Devo was initially just a guy
who was out there but what ended up
happening is that Omega actually
developed what were essentially
mind-altering glasses that led him to
believe that he lived this life
alongside her and maybe he he did right
maybe he actually did we're not fully
told if that's the case but basically he
ended up seeing the destruction of the
human population and that's why orcas in
all this is being done is to ensure
their own Survival and it's and it's
crazy because from what from here what
you do is you actually transition to
Terra verdict that basically that's
where Maura McTaggart was taken when she
was kidnapped by orcas and that uh
mystique and destiny were seemingly
given this information by Emma Frost and
that what happens is when they arrive on
the scene that it looks as though more
Mitch Haggard has either been defeated
or killed but one way or another is kind
of hard to tell you basically end up
having Destiny and Mystique who were at
this location that seemed to be
basically tormenting uh more mchaggard
again we're not really sure if she is
dead now like literally you kind of have
those moments when she's seemingly being
tortured by mystique and Destiny so of
course she seems alive at that moment
but when you have Xavier and Magneto
walk in like her arms just sitting there
in a chair so it looks like they did
just lock her arm off and now they just
got her in some other location and
that's basically it but a trap has
effectively been set because when when
Xavier and Magneto walk in here suddenly
the teleportation portal starts
activating and when it does you get a
whole bunch of foot soldiers coming in
and then you get nimrod
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Inferno Magneto versus
Nimrod and it's really more Magneto and
Charles Xavier versus Nimrod and the
fight is epic
it's ridiculously epic okay so here's
the funny thing this is the conclusion
of Inferno and initially I forgot that
it was four issues long right like I got
to the end of the story and I was like I
mean this is weird it's a weird way to
end the comic like it feels like it's
over right and then I looked it up and I
was like well that's because it is over
right because Marvel does so many six
issue stories now that is almost kind of
weird when they drop a four issue series
and like that's it right it just kind of
takes you by surprise but in the last
video that we did we basically covered
the cover the segment and really cover
the events where essentially Destiny and
Mystique had gotten their hands on
Warren mctagger they had taken her we
didn't know exactly how they did it we
simply just knew that they had and the
result to this is that Xavier and
Magneto were led into a trap where they
believed more mctaggard had been taken
where they believed that mystique and
destiny were holding more image Hatter
which was on the Forge and so as soon as
Magneto and Xavier teleport here they're
immediately met by the arrival of all
these orcas forces now once all that
stuff pops off right once everything
happens here it gets kind of crazy
because you had a kind of conversation
between Magneto and and Xavier well
remember Magneto can gently lift his
helmet and he can overhear the
telepathic thoughts of Xavier anything
short of that and Xavier will be able to
get in right Magneto won't be able to
hear anything Xavier is saying
telepathically the result of this is
that they kind of have this quick bit of
a discussion where they're like that's
Nimrod right like Nimrod is alive and
well I mean they kind of knew he was
alive and well but as you guys know when
it comes to somebody like Nimrod there's
a big difference between hearing he's
alive having it reported to you that
he's alive and standing in front of
nimrod right because as we know Nimrod
killed apocalypse right at one of the
different lifespans of of Maura
mctaggard Nimrod killed apocalypse this
is no small thing right this guy is
literally a living weapon he can he can
determine what your powers are and then
basically develop the systems he needs
to essentially counter them or even
negate your powers but the crazy thing
about this is that you have this kind of
thing where Omega right remember she's
basically kind of like a future version
of herself or at least a version from
the timeline where she's there to
basically make sure that the war pops
off the way that it's supposed to and
the rise of the Machines actually take
place right so like this Sentinel
program develops as opposed to all of
which will basically lead to this moment
and then presumably in the future uh the
idea of machines conquering humanity and
the mutant population and so when you
have one of the orcas agents who says
like like this is your last chance to go
the response to Nimrod is like you guys
not realize the look in these guys eyes
and the eyes of Xavier and Magneto
they're ready to die right they're ready
to die for their cause and the orcas
ages response is so would we and the
response of Omega is and so you have and
literally like Nimrod and Omega
eradicate every single orcas agent here
right they kill them all like that it
happens so fast none of these guys ever
had a chance the reason behind why they
did this is because
Omega and nimrod hate humanity and the
reason why they hate humanity is
remember that while Omega is still more
of a cyborg than she is a pure human she
allies herself more with the machine
than she does with her biological
components Nimrod is just full-on
machine right he's literally an
artificial intelligence that has
basically gained uh gained you know
sentience right gained its own level of
self-awareness and operates according to
essentially ensuring that the mutant
population is destroyed but throughout
the entire history of Humanity's use of
machines they were tools right that's
the thing that this really kind of said
here by by Omega is like they're tools
and it's one of these funny things is
because from their perspective and it's
almost one of these things where hipping
kind of toys with the idea of like
Skynet right Terminator that kind of a
thing the whole idea behind like the
animatrix the war between like man and
machine this notion that like robots can
basically have feelings right they they
can experience sadness and anger and
pain and so on and so forth now of
course in in Marvel Comics machines are
very very human in terms of how they're
depicted the only real exception to that
are like Sentinels but the important
thing here is that humanity is always
viewed and used machines as tools but
machines themselves write Nimrod being
used as a tool to destroy the mutant
populations so on and so forth right it
basically pisses them off they've hated
Humanity because of it and so that
really seems to be and and really seems
to be the basis behind why it is that
the machine population waged a war
against humans and mutants and it's why
it looks like in that far-flung future
Humanity basically had to merge with
like proto-humans right like the next
stage of human evolution those
individuals who were locked away in the
vault right we saw those they escaped
for a time and then basically they went
back in again right those guys right why
Humanity had to merge with them because
it was the only way for Humanity to
survive that in the face of a war
between super advanced technology and
mutants who could have powers ranging
from the ability to read minds spanning
all the way up to controlling the entire
Earth's electromagnetic spectrum
Humanity was powerless there was
basically nothing they could do
especially when the one weapon they did
have which was machines turned on them
right into so you get this crazy thing
because at that point like literally
Magneto just grabs a giant satellite
just brings it crashing down on him
which both of them knew nothing was
gonna happen because of that right
you're gonna It's A Hard Sell to get
anyone to believe that that Nimrod could
be killed by a multi-ton piece of just
Machinery that's never going to happen
and in fact Omega and and Nimrod both
escape the entire thing and like the
fight basically begins to break out now
at that point Xavier and really what
he's trying to do here is find where
more McTaggart is right I mean they want
to escape with their lives but they also
realize the longer this fight goes on
for the higher the likelihood they are
going to die because the reality is
while Magneto is powerful and while
Xavier is powerful they're not on the
level of power they need to defeat
people like Omega or Nimrod right they
just don't have that level of power and
so you get this kind of crazy moment
here where Xavier just like freaks out
lashes out and attacks Nimrod and just
lets off this massive burst of energy
which actually shatters nimrod's entire
brain now on that surface right there
you would think that he would be killed
but before we find out you actually
switch directly over to uh to mystique
and to Destiny the reason being is
because while more may taggart's here
remember Dave's got a vendetta their
desire is to kill Mora mctagger and so
when they're here down in this place
below krakowa literally a gun is pulled
by mystique and when the question of
mermaid taggard is are you really gonna
kill me right you realize if you kill me
the entire universe will will start over
again a new timeline will be created you
will have forgotten all of this maybe
Destiny could come back and maybe
Destiny will remember it all we won't
know for sure but everything that's
happened here will be obliterated and
the responsive Mystique is yes and she
pulls the trigger and everything Fades
right everything just blips and like
that's it at that point you jump back
right to the initial conversation that
was that took place between Emma Frost
and Mystique and Destiny we didn't know
exactly what tools Emma Frost had given
to Mystique in and Destiny to help them
achieve their goal of capturing Mormon
taggard and then presumably killing more
mctaggard and being able to do it all
without Charles Xavier or Magneto
realizing what their intention was what
you end up finding out here is that with
this whole thing going on because their
goal is to kill Mora of course Emma says
the same thing if you kill her you will
restart reality you cannot kill her as
long as she is a mutant that cannot be
allowed to happen and so at that point
Mystique just kind of kind of starts to
realize what it is that Mystique is
saying and she says Forge once told me
about the worst weapon he ever made a
gun that turns us into them that makes a
mutant human but I saw the look in his
eyes he would never give that to us
willingly he would never ever ever do
that and that's when Emma Frost presents
the gun Rashi says guess how to find
Mora and what to do with her once you
have and so what you end up finding out
here is this is the craziest thing what
you end up finding out here is that
every instance were Maura McTaggart was
basically taken by Mystique right
everything that had to happen in order
for that to take place it was all
orchestrated By Mystique who was
shape-shifting but it was all
orchestrated by her shape-shifting into
people switching from one person to the
next right creating dissent and
confusion among the ranks of orcas
driving them to attack each other and
then tricking Nimrod and Omega into
fighting Charles Xavier and Magneto
right literally Mystique orchestrated
all of it now here's the reason why that
matters right over the years and really
in more recent years just the the
overall dangerous nature of Mystique has
fallen to the Wayside and a lot of
that's because Marvel never really did
anything meaningful with her right she
was just there and Marvel kept her
around because she was a Legacy
character right she had been a Legacy
character since the days of Chris
Claremont she'd been a Legacy character
since like the old school X-Men Days
she'd been a Legacy character since
X-Men the Animated Series right I mean
she just been around that long that she
was a character you just couldn't really
kill off for any real measure of time
but there was nothing really ever done
with her that really Illustrated how
capable she was what this does right
here is show you just how dangerous
Mystique is right if the world does not
succumb to complete and total nuclear
catastrophe it's because Mystique
allowed it like that's really how
dangerous she is at any point in time
Mystique can impersonate a sitting
president and then press the button and
just launch a nuclear Arsenal at another
country and there goes the world that's
the nature of Mystique right you could
quite literally craft a story where
Mystique Kills the Marvel Universe and
it would be believable right she's that
capable and it's so great to see
Jonathan Hickman just like do her
character Justice right it's just it's
so great to see somebody who's not like
yeah there's a mistake she's a person
there no to be like no man like Mystique
dude she's on a whole different level
right this girl has been around for for
quite some time she's almost as old as
Wolverine is uh and she is stupidly
dangerous right and so that's when you
have this kind of crazy thing where
basically Mystique reveals to More
mctagon We Made You human right like we
made you a human and that's it and so
that's what more is like that's your
plan is to like take my Powers away and
then kill me like that's that's that's
it and so that's what Maura McTaggart
basically spills the beans it says you
hardly understand what's going on here
right like your your desire to kill me
here is because of some Vendetta where
I've basically been messing with
timelines and stuff like that and like
you set me on fire right and I like I've
been hiding from us a lot and so we're
like you think you understand what's
going on you have no clue this timeline
right this whole this whole
I basically drove Xavier and Magneto to
form the quiet Council to build the
nation of krakowa from their perspective
I'm saving the mutant population the
reality is I don't care anything about
krakowa I don't care anything about the
meetings on krakowa right I have lived
these lives a thousand times I have seen
this happen so many times and every time
it ends the same way it ends in a war
between the human population and the
mutant population and the Machine
population and humans sometimes merge
with the post-human race and sometimes
they're destroyed by the post-human race
and all this left are post-humans and
machines and mutants but no matter how
it happens no matter what takes place no
matter how it unfolds mutants always die
we always get destroyed every single
time without fail that's what happens
there's no way to stop that if any
timeline is created out there that
allows the mutant population to
propagate long enough we will be
obliterated the reason why I created
krakowa the reason why I orchestrated
Xavier and Magneto doing this forming
the Kauai Council and consolidating the
entire meat and population down if so I
could destroy it so that what I could do
is quite literally start manipulating
things behind the scenes so that kids
who were born on krakowa are born
without powers that I would basically
neutralize them this gun you have in
your hand it's a basic simple thing
right it takes the powers away from a
person I aim for mutant genocide I aim
to set things up so that there will
never be mutants who are born again
right so this war between the mutant
population and any other populations out
there will never come to fruition the
mutant race Will Survive because a
mutant race will not exist all of us
will be made into humans that was the
goal of Maura McTaggart and it's just
like damn son like she was basically
boxing the mutant population in so she
could Wipe Out the mutant population
that's nuts right basically we would
sterilize the mutant Gene in the mutant
population and that would be it and it's
just like okay like this is crazy like
this is this is absolutely nuts and so
at that point you switch over to to
Professor X and you switch over to
Magneto right now here's what here's a
crazy thing that goes on here Magneto
was playing possum with Omega right like
Charles Xavier hits up Magneto and says
we're running out of time we have to
find Maura and man you know says yes I
know Charles we will right and that's
when when he asks Omega like you heard
him didn't you right we have a question
that we want to answer and the answer of
Omega is you shouldn't worry about him
you should worry about yourself and the
response of Magneto is no you should
worry about me and like seizes the
mechanical components of Omega right
like this is she's man
oh man
man this is about to get not Sun okay
here's another here's
oh dude it's it's man y'all are not
prepared right so so here's the thing
while all that's going on right like
like remember like literally like Xavier
destroyed the head of of nimad but
remember Nimrod can reconstitute himself
and this is a far more advanced version
right remember the original Nimrod is
referred to as Nimrod the Lesser this
was referred to as Nimrod the greater
he's more powerful and he can regenerate
faster right this guy is designed to
just be an absolute wrecking machine and
that's literally what happens is it's
like like as Magneto is basically
interrogating Omega by pulling her
machine components off of her body that
immediately as soon as Nimrod
reconstitutes he grabs Xavier and that's
when he tells Magneto he was just like
we don't have time for this right like
here's the thing to understand you
probably need this guy as much as I need
her so you have to ask yourself how much
will others have to pay when your
actions put their lives on the line now
the crazy thing here is Xavier basically
tells Magneto no we should leave like we
should leave here right now now they
will kill us if we stay but Magneto
won't he won't give he's like no that's
not gonna happen like I'm not giving it
up like like there's no circumstance
where you lead here alive in Iran right
now nimrod's whole thing is if you let
her go I will let him go we'll call
today a draw we'll go our separate ways
and so essentially it's kind of nimrod
and Xavier who are someone on the same
side here where it's like Magneto let
them go right and it's one of those
crazy things right man he knows I hear
this machine I have lost everything
multiple times so I am well conditioned
to accept some small losses for greater
gains and so because of the fact the
nimrod's basically told I will do I will
die and destroy you here before I let
anything else go on in this place the
response of of nimrod is fine then
ultimately this is a grudge between you
and me so then we'll make it a grudge
between you and me right like I will let
them go I will let Xavier go and and you
will let Omega go and then you will like
they will leave they'll get out of here
and then it'll just come down to you and
me and so the response of man you know
is what do you want me to do Charles
right now this is very very important
right Charles says they don't have more
McTaggart Eric she's somewhere else that
knowledge will die with us we have to
try you have to trust them right like if
we die here right now we will not
remember where more mctaggard is like
all this information that we've gained
here we won't recall and so we'll
basically have to start this search all
over again and so in term Magneto's like
fine I'd agree I agree to your terms
release him and the response of nimrod I
am so sorry you trusted me flap and then
just totally eradicates Xavier at that
point Magneto loses it just totally
loses it just just freaks out just
totally crushes Omega right and then at
that point goes after Nimrod but
remember Nimrod can duplicate and so at
that point it's just creating duplicates
of himself right and so it's literally
Magneto fighting two nimrods and it is
crazy because while that's going on
Omega is still somewhat alive right it's
still like she's still somewhat there
man here's here's a great thing man
Magneto is holding his own against two
nimrods man that's no small thing right
like like understand a nimrod killed
apocalypse magnetos holding his own
against two right it's it's crazy to see
this happening right now here's the
kicker behind all this omega's not dead
right I mean her body's basically ripped
to pieces she's all over the damn place
but she can still communicate with her
psychic components and at that point
like literally she says like I have
something special for you mutant a
surprise a power dampener activates it
and shuts off the magnetic abilities of
Magneto as soon as that happens Here
Comes Nimrod and it's wow Nimrod takes
out Magneto and at that point Omega
reconstitutes herself and then like
literally Magneto is just kind of laying
there right he's like this is not over
right like there's no way this is this
is over right we're gonna keep going
like we're gonna keep fighting and the
response to them is like no right and
they literally blow the whole place up
right they just detonate the whole spot
and Magneto's like I will see you again
right and the response of Omega is of
course you will mutant it's inevitable
right it's inevitable we will meet again
we will see you in the future and when
that war comes we'll destroy you then
too at that point switch back over to
mystique and to uh into it and Destiny
right just crazy ass thing so you have
this whole conversation going on right
where it's like okay so the goal of of
more mctaggard here was to basically
sterilize the mutant population over the
course of a couple generations and then
basically ensure that the mutant
population had no powers by the time
this war came to fruition right and so
basically they're just like let's kill
her right let's just kill her and be
done with it enter Douglas Ramsey right
Cypher now remember Cipher's been
watching all of this and it and that was
one of the things that was established
right this is why Jonathan Hickman
writing is so important is because
things that were referenced a couple
issues ago or things that were
referenced a year and a half ago are
incredibly important by the time you get
to the end and so to kind of reiterate
here one of the things that we'd learned
is that as soon as Doug Ramsey was
contacted by Professor Xavier to visit
the island of krakowa and to basically
find a way to turn that place into a
kind of a refuge for the mutant
population Cipher never never believed
in Xavier I mean he believed in him but
didn't believe him right he thought that
there was something else going on he's
like I've I've been a new Mutant I've
been an X-Man I've been a part of the
mutant Community long enough to know
that Xavier is not the most trustworthy
person out there and so working
alongside Warlock and basically the
island of gracoa itself that where where
uh the The Hub of more McTaggart was
created and it was basically going to be
hidden from the eyes of everybody except
for those who could access it Douglas
Ramsey used the power of warlock to
basically create a kind of back door for
himself so he could witness everything
that was going on so every single
conversation that had ever transpired
between Maura mctaggard and Xavier and
Magneto everything else that would
everything that was supposed to be
hidden from the mutant population where
no one was supposed to know what was
actually going on Cipher knew it Douglas
Ramsey knew it and then for for a really
interesting reason that's not that this
doesn't seemingly seem to be made clear
that Douglas Ramsey believes in krakowa
even if he doesn't necessarily believe
in in the ideologies or the philosophies
of Xavier and Magneto and especially not
more mctaggard he believes in what can
happen here on krakowa and he's been
watching all this unfold and so as soon
as he arrives he basically says okay
here's the thing Mystique you could kill
Amora McTaggart but here's the problem I
believe in the laws that we have here
and what's the first law of krakowa
murder no man you have made more
McTaggart a human now you intend to kill
them you intend to violate one of the
most sacred law of krakowa which is not
to kill a human without that human
having been put on trial or to simply
just not kill them at all right these
laws that you fashioned for the rest of
the mutant population now you're going
to break through themselves is that how
it is right like the rules are for thee
not for me right is that I mean are you
Reddit why do you create rules everybody
else has to follow but you don't follow
them yourself is that really what this
is and so at that point that's when
Destiny chimes in because where
mystique's like well I mean okay fine we
could just kill you and be done with it
right like we could just kill you right
here right and then you could be reborn
and you'll never remember any of this
Doug Ramsay you'll never recall any of
what happened here because I sit on the
quiet Council and I can manipulate
behind the scenes and determine what it
is that you do and do not recall right
Corruption of the highest order but at
that point Doug Ramsay's like I mean
that's possible but what about all of
them and that's when he brings in right
they the blood moon his wife from the
Ten of Swords event you guys remember
that she's wildly deadly there's no way
Mystique could take on Bay right I mean
that's just that's never gonna happen
Mystique is capable but she's not gonna
kill this scroll right and then there's
just the whole island of krakowa which
at any point in time could just expel
the mutant population just be like
you're all out of here right everybody
leave right literally evict them from
their own home like it's any one of
these things and so at that point
there's no way Mystique could basically
kill Doug Ramsey without her actions
being made public and then she'd
essentially be confined to the pit for
pretty much for all eternity just
sitting down there with Sabretooth and
so as a result to this that's when
Destiny chimes in and says no here's the
thing if you kill Doug right now yo
you'll basically be confined right
that'll it'll be the end of you I will
remain on the quiet Council but I will
die six months later and that Douglas
Ramsey will basically remain in his
current position right that he'll be
reborn and that everybody will know what
you did everything will go on and like
literally for you and I we lose for
everybody else they win and then the
question is well then what do we do
about more McTaggart and the response of
Destiny is Mormon tagger's future if
fluxes wildly right at branches who
knows what's going to happen here right
like we have no clue what's going to
happen with our character all we know is
that she's human now so whatever world
is out there for her she's going to have
to just figure it out on her own and so
in turn Doug Ramsey's like okay your
life is saved more mctagger but
understand you're now exiled you can
never come back to the to the the nation
of kakoa like literally krakowa will let
you use this gate one final time but as
soon as you pass through this gate all
gates to the mutant nation of krakowa
will be closed to you right it'll give
you a head start and so in turn you have
like this kind of amazing statement
that's made by Mystique right where she
says like you have what you've always
wanted more of a tagger you have your
Humanity enjoy it while you can enjoy it
while you run right the response let me
seeing is like we're going to find you
and we're going to kill you make no
mistake mystique and Destiny would
forego their inclusion as part of The
Quiet Council to kill Mora McTaggart but
also understand Gourmet tiger will be
out there in the world there's nowhere
she can go where she can hide from
mystique and Destiny one even if Destiny
wasn't here mystique's cable enough has
enough resources and enough contacts she
could find her but two Destiny being
here she's a precog she would ultimately
be able to find out where Mormon tagger
is somewhere along the line right as
more mctaggard's future becomes more
clear they would ultimately be able to
locate her and so because of that like
her days are numbered it's only a matter
of time before Maura McTaggart dies and
so picking up one week after all of this
Magneto and Professor Xavier are brought
back and when the questions asked how
much time has passed right how long has
it been the response of Emma Frost is
long enough for things to change
especially those which needed it most
and so when Xavier asks like what have
you done Emma she says exactly what you
would have done Charles something quite
radical I told the entire quiet Council
everything that had happened I told them
about Mormon Taggart I told them about
your secret meetings with Maura
mctaggard I told them everything you had
kept hidden from them but here's the
irony of this the choir Council
seemingly agreed that Charles Xavier and
Magneto keeping these secrets from the
rest of the mutant population was the
right thing the mistake was keeping
those Secrets From The Quiet Council now
here's an important distinction to
understand right let's say that like
NASA with their Advanced telescopes and
all that kind of stuff figured out that
a meteor was coming to Earth and it was
going to crash into the Earth in the
next like three years right like it was
on a collision course it was going to
hit the world it was going to wipe out
all life on the planet the question you
have to ask is should Humanity be told
the correct answer to that question is
no you do not tell the rest of humanity
why because Humanity will do the only
thing it knows how to do in a time of
desperation it will panic and when that
happens it'll just create chaos right
literally Humanity will destroy the
world before the meteor does that's
exactly what's going to happen that
human beings cannot be trusted with the
knowledge of their impending death right
the humanity has consistently Time and
Time and Again shown that it cannot
handle that kind of information if the
quiet Council had revealed all of this
to the entire mutant population it would
have destroyed everything right it would
have destroyed everything that had
happened right and it probably would
have led to some kind of a civil war
among the mutant population that Civil
War would have spread out into the rest
of the world and then all warmongering
eyes would have fallen on the nation of
krakowa and literally the mutant
population would have brought about its
own destruction because some kind of
conflict somewhere would have led to the
shores of some human Nation somewhere
and would have inflicted catastrophic
damage right I mean you guys remember
the events of Civil War when nitro
detonated a Stamford Connecticut and
that initiated the the passage of
sweeping legislation regarding the
ability for superheroes to act with
their identities being kept private and
so at the end of the day the cry Castle
agrees this information will stay with
us right the quiet council is accursed
as much as it is a burden now right like
the information that you have is now our
information we have to go forward
essentially knowing that our own Doom is
impending and we have to try to find
some way to keep that from happening and
so what this does is this ends Jonathan
Hickman's work on on the X-Men what it
looks like after this I have no clue but
Jonathan Hickman's gone right he's done
he's actually been gone for Marvel for a
little while now right he's working on
three was the three worlds three moons
whatever it is with like Scott Snyder
and all those guys so he's doing his own
thing but like right now uh yeah
Hickman's run is finished Hickman's work
is done at this point who knows like we
know we have Jerry Conway riding X-Men
right now but who knows how the X-Men
landscape's gonna look it could be in
two years mama just sets everything back
to the way it was before and goes back
to writing crappy X-Men stories we you
know who knows but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace